this complete c plus plus course will
take you from being an absolute beginner
to using advanced c plus plus features
danielle gaguaya teaches this course he
is an experienced software developer and
has created many popular courses
hello guys and welcome to this modern c
plus plus 20 course this is a course
that is going to take you from the
absolute beginning where you know
nothing about c plus plus and you're
going to go all the way to a point where
you can use some advanced features in
the c plus plus programming language
that includes things like
object-oriented programming with
inheritance and polymorphism with the c
plus plus programming language now i'm
not going to spend a lot of time
convincing you on why you should use c
plus plus but c plus plus is a very
powerful programming language you can
use to do all kinds of crazy things you
can use it to do systems programming you
can build games with it and it is used
in a wide range of areas so you can do a
lot with c plus plus now who is this
course for this course is built for
complete beginners if you already have
some experience with c plus plus you
will still find some good things you can
learn from the course but i am going to
go from the absolute beginning showing
you every little thing showing you the
tools showing you the compilers and the
editor we're going to be using here so
we're going to spend a lot of time
making sure you understand the
fundamentals by the time you are done
with this course you will understand the
bare fundamentals about c plus we will
spend a lot of time exploring the
procedure programming side of c plus
plus so you're going to be writing
programs that run from top to bottom and
we're going to spend a lot of time in
the editor writing code making sure you
really understand what is going on here
towards the end we're going to learn
about object oriented programming and
we're going to touch on classes
inheritance and polymorphism and these
are the tools you're going to be using a
lot in your career as a c plus plus
developer another great feature of this
course is that we spend a lot of time
making sure you understand the tools so
if you don't know what a compiler is if
you don't know what an ide is we're
going to make sure you understand these
things and we're going to spend a lot of
time using these things and by the time
you're done with the course you're going
to be very comfortable using the tools
the editor of choice for the course is
going to be visual studio code so that's
an editor that is going to allow us to
type in the code and give us some things
like a syntax highlighting but we're
going to be connecting our editor to a
background compiler which is going to
make sure our code is transformed
to run on our computer but don't worry
about all that craziness right now we're
going to go in detail about these things
for now i just want you to have a bird's
eye view on what you can expect from the
course here now i hope you know what to
expect from the course but i also expect
you to be ready to take the course and
the requirements are really not that bad
the only requirement is that you have
time set aside to really practice what
you learn from the course here and you
need to have a strong drive and
willingness to learn now if you want to
follow along i am going to share a link
to the github repository for the code i
use in the course so you can check that
out and really follow along if you want
if you want some support we have a
discord server dedicated for our
students so you can join and be part of
the community if you have a question you
can ask but another thing i would
encourage you to do is to also help
others so if you see somebody asking a
question try to help them you're going
to learn a lot that way okay now that
you know a bit about the course let's
talk about myself here my name is daniel
cacoya i am a software engineer i have
been writing code since 2011 or
something
and i am a professional c plus plus
developer i do a lot of freelance work i
work for a few companies i do all kinds
of crazy things i also like to teach
others so i have a few courses on udemy
if you are interested in cute you can
check these things out i also have a
trending c plus plus course that you can
check out but don't feel the need to go
and check this ziplesque course out
because a lot is covered in this youtube
course here so that's really all about
me okay now that you have an idea about
the course we're going to head over in
the next lecture and learn about the
tools we're going to be using throughout
the course here go ahead and finish up
here and meet me there
welcome to this new chapter where we're
going to be exploring the c plus plus
development tools you need to start
writing your own c plus plus
applications and you really need two
kinds of tools the first one is going to
be an editor or an ide through which
you're going to be writing your c plus
plus code we are going to be using
visual studio code as an editor in this
course because it is very easy to
install it is cross-platform it is going
to run well on windows mac and linux and
it supports a host of tools that are
going to make your job easier as a
surplus plus developer but that's not to
say you can't use your favorite ide if
you can but visual studio code is going
to be our main editor in this course so
i would recommend installing it to be
able to follow along with what we do
here now after we have an ide or an
editor in place we will need a compiler
and the compiler is a piece of software
that takes the code we write in the
editor and compiles that into code that
can directly run on the hardware or
binary executable format so this is what
we're going to be doing here we're going
to be typing our code in an editor like
visual studio code we're going to be
kicking off a process to compile our
program and this is going to turn our
program into a format that can run it
directly on the hardware so for example
if you are on a windows machine you're
going to generate a binary executable
that can directly run on windows if you
are on linux we will generate a binary
that can run on linux and the same
concepts can really extend on mac or any
other kind of operating system you might
be working on with the course here so we
need two tools we need an ide or an
editor and a compiler and the tools you
install are going to be depending on the
operating system you are using to watch
the course if you are on windows you're
going to install a set of tools that are
specific to windows if you are on linux
you're going to install a set of tools
for linux if you are on a mac you're
going to install a set of tools specific
to the apple operating system for
desktop now on windows in terms of ides
or integrated development environment it
is possible to use a host of ides for
example you can use code lite it is an
ide you can use you can use microsoft
visual studio but in this course we're
going to be using visual studio code
because it is easy to install it has a
set of features that are really good it
is popular it has a great community
around it i think you're going to have a
great time as a beginner to start
writing your c plus plus programs using
visual studio code that's not to say
that you can't use another ide you can
if you want but i am going to be using
visual studio code in this course here
now on linux we are also going to be
using visual studio code as our editor
in the course but there are other ides
you can use for example you can use cute
creator if you want you can use
codelight you can use a host of other
ides on linux but again visual studio
code is going to be our thing in the
course here and i would recommend
installing it on your linux box if you
are watching this course on the linux
machine so for osx we are also going to
be using visual studio code as our
editor as i said it is cross platforms
it runs where regardless of the
operating system you might be using to
watch the course but if you want you can
use the apple
ide which is xcode or even code lite all
these are going to work if you want but
again i would recommend going with
visual studio code.plus to start out so
that we have a common ground and you
don't get confused very easily
especially if you are a beginner now
after we have an ide rolling we will
need a compiler
and as we say the compiler is a tool
that is going to transform your c plus
plus code into a format that can run
directly on the hardware so the compiler
you use again is going to depend on the
operating system where you are watching
the course i am going to show you a
bunch of compilers you can use but gcc
is going to be our common base so on
windows i will be using what we call
mingw don't worry if you don't what it
is i am going to show you in a minute
when we install it but this is a project
that brings the gcc compiler on windows
so that we can use it easily and i am
going to show you how to install it but
i am also going to show you how to
install the compiler from microsoft and
the clang llvm compiler these are all
available to you on windows and it is
really easy to install them these days
and i will be using them all if you are
on windows i would recommend installing
them all so that you really have a
chance to try your c plus plus code on
the different compilers and that's a
really good thing to do if you test your
c plus plus code against multiple
compilers you will be increasing your
chances for your code to really be
portable and work on multiple compilers
and operating systems and that cannot be
a bad thing so i would recommend
installing all these compilers if you
are on windows i am also going to show
you how to install two compilers on
linux i am going to show you gcc we're
going to install the shiny new feature
in gcc we're going to install clang lvm
on linux and we will be able to use all
these compilers again if you are on
linux i would recommend installing all
these compilers so that you have a
chance to try your code against multiple
compilers and that's going to make your
code much portable and easier to use on
multiple compilers and platforms on the
mac i am going to show you how to
install gcc
and i am going to show you how to
install clangle lvm but if you want you
can also install xcode and the compiler
that comes with that for c plus but
development all these are options to you
but again in this course we are mostly
going to be using the gcc compiler so i
would recommend getting a hold of this
if you don't want to install other
compilers if you only have to install
one compiler please install gcc that's
going to be our main compiler in the
course here okay so these are the tools
we need we are going to head over in the
next lecture and show you how to install
the visual studio code editor on windows
and really get started with that
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
in the next lecture this video i am
going to show you how to install a c
plus plus compiler on your windows
operating system so we're going to be
looking at three kinds of compilers
we're going to look at the mingw
compiler which gives us access to a gcc
like compiler on windows we're going to
look at clan llvm which is another
compiler we're going to look at the
compiler from microsoft
now before we talk about any compiler i
would like you to come to google or your
favorite search engine and say
c plus plus compiler support okay so
we're going to choose this little guy
here and this is really going to give us
a berg's eye view
on which feature is supported by which c
plus plus compiler for example if we are
interested in c plus plus 20 which is
the lattice standard that we have in
simplest plus at the time of recording
this video i am recording of this in
august
2021 but if we go here we're going to
see c plus plus 20 core features and
we're going to see that we have a list
of what each compiler supports we have
gcc we have clan we have msvc we have
the clan version from the apple company
and if we scroll down we can really see
the features that are supported by each
compiler again gcc is going to be our
choice in this course this is going to
be our main compiler but nothing really
stops you from using the clan compiler
or the msvc compiler and if you happen
to see that your compiler of choice
doesn't support what you need for
example you can see that at the current
time lambdas in an evaluated context are
not supported in clan
you can see that it is ready here but
this is a feature you can use both in
gcc and the msvc compiler from microsoft
so keep an eye out on this page here to
know which kind of things you can use in
your compiler if you try something out
and you see that it doesn't work this is
a good place to come and figure out if
your compiler supports the feature that
you are using in this video i am going
to show you how to install the three
most common compilers and those are gcc
clang msvc if you want you can come in
your search engine and type gcc to see
what this is it is a good thing to do to
learn about your tools here you can see
that it is a compiler that is mostly
used on the lenox platform but we can
also use it on windows the latest
release that we're going to be
installing is eleven two zero i think it
was released
six days ago so it is really fresh and
we're going to be taking advantage of
this another thing i should say here is
that you should install the latest tools
you can get your hands upon this is the
version we're going to be mostly using
in this course but if you are watching
this in the future you're going to have
a newer version i would recommend
installing the latest version or the
newest version you can get your hands
upon so the first we're going to do is
install a gcc compiler on windows i am
going to show you a way we can get both
gcc and clang in one go and to get
access to that please go in your search
engine and type windlabs and this is
going to bring us to this project here
if you want you can click upon this
and this is a cool project by a guy who
is providing worlds for these compilers
that we can use on windows
so if you want you can just go down here
and look at the lettuce releases again i
recommend using the
lettuce you can get your hands upon in
this case the lettuce happens to be 1120
but in the future this is going to
change you're going to find a version
for 12 or 13 so please grab the newest
version you can get your hands up on now
i want you to install the version that
says that it has llvm and clang so if
you are on a 32-bit version on windows i
would recommend getting this 7-zip
archive on this zip archive here if you
are on 64 i would recommend getting a
hold of this or this little thing here
it doesn't really matter but make sure
you get the latest version you can get
your hands upon and you can see that
this conveniently says latest here so i
am going to download the 64-bit version
on windows i am going to grab the zip
archive here and let's click upon this
this should kick off my download and
this is going to download on my system i
can download this if i want and you're
going to see that it is going to start
downloading here and i am going to wait
for this to finish again this is going
to give us both the gcc compiler and the
clan compiler and this is really like
shooting two birds with one stone so
this is going to be really good i
already have this downloaded so i am
just going to head over to the location
where i have this downloaded i think i
can just go in my drive here
so let's crack this open and go in my
downloads folder
and if i go in my compressed folder i am
going to find winlabs llvm and mingw
this is what you really want but if you
don't want the clan compiler you can
grab the one that doesn't say llvm here
because we really want both of these
compilers we are going to grab the one
that has both the gcc compiler and the
clan compiler if we crack this open
let's open this together so that you can
see what is happening we are going to
have this little folder here if we go in
we're going to find a bin folder if we
go in and crack that open we're going to
have a folder
that says clang you see we have a clang
compiler we have our clan plus plus
compiler for c plus plus and if we go
down we're going to find our g plus plus
compiler and the gcc compiler this is
what we want so what we are going to do
is extract this somewhere on our system
i put this on my c drive so if you go
here you're going to find mingw64
so all you really have to do is go where
you downloaded your compiler
and say extract we're going to right
click on this
and say extract to a location and you're
going to specify where you want this to
go and this is going to be extracted or
even if you want you can extract here
this is something i like to do this is
going to show up in the current folder
and you can grab this and paste that in
a location where you want this in my
case i put this in my c drive as i said
here so this is going to be my compiler
now once you have these compilers
installed again we have the clan
compiler we have the gcc compiler if we
go down we're going to find the g plus
plus we even have gdb which is a
debugger we can use to debug c plus plus
applications but we will talk about this
later once you have this i would
recommend putting this in your
environment variables on windows the way
you do this you grab this path well we
have our compilers here and we're going
to copy this this is something i
recommend
and on windows 10 you can go on the
start menu and type env
and this is going to give us a window in
which we can edit our environment
variables we're going to click on this
little thing this is going to open up on
our system we're going to wait for this
to open up and we're going to have a
window that says system properties we're
going to click on environment variables
here and we can put this in our user
environment variables or on our system
environment variables since i am the
only one using this system i like to put
this in my path for my system variables
so i am going to click on path and click
edit here and i am going to add a path
to my gcc and cloud installation here
you can see that right here if you don't
have this end you can click on new
you're going to have a window here and
you can paste this right in and you can
click ok but i'm not going to do that
because i already have this in here so
what i am going to do is just delete
this let's see if i can delete i can
delete this little guy and i have my
path in here so if you don't have this
in please make sure you have this in
your environment variables so we're
going to cancel out of this but if this
is the first time you do this you should
click ok and one way to test that your
environment variables are working or
even if your compilers are working
is to crack up a command line terminal
so we're going to say cmd on the start
menu here
and all you need to do is say g plus
plus just like this dash dash version
if you do this you're going to see
information about your c plus plus
compiler
and this is coming from the installation
we just did and for clan you can say
clan plus plus version and this is going
to tell you the information about your
clan compiler installation let's wait
for this to come up i don't know why
it's slow but you can see that we have a
clank compiler the lattice version is
1201 for the gcc compiler the latest
version is 1120
and these are the compilers we can use
to write c plus plus 20 applications
okay so by now we have a gcc compiler
through the main gw project we have a
client llcm compiler on our system we
are also going to see how to get a hold
of the compiler from microsoft and to
get hold of this you need to install
microsoft visual studio
to install microsoft visual studio all
you have to do is come to your favorite
search engine and say microsoft visual
studio we can look at the 2019 version
which is the latest i think and we're
going to click on the download link here
we have as the first link and we're
going to see ways we can download this
little guy now microsoft visual studio
has a community version you can download
for free but we also have a professional
and enterprise versions that we're not
going to care about in this course here
we are just going to download
the community version and that's going
to be enough for our purposes here so if
you click on free download here this is
going to download and install the visual
studio compiler you can click on this
little guy and it is going to download
an installer you're going to crack this
open on your system and it is going to
install the visual studio installer so
once you have it installed you can come
to the start menu here
and say visual studio installer i think
if you say visual studio you're going to
have this pop-up somewhere on your
system we're going to click on this and
if you crack the installer open you're
going to see a window like this which is
really going to give you a chance to
install the tools you want to use with
the microsoft visual studio
ide and in this case we are interested
in desktop development with c plus plus
so we're going to click this little guy
here we're going to take it open
and once you do this you going to click
download and install and this is going
to install the visual studio compiler
with the underlying compiler you see
that this is going to give us access to
the msvc compiler and all kinds of crazy
things we really needed to write c plus
plus applications on windows using the
compiler from microsoft now i have to
say this is going to take some time to
install so if you see that this takes up
20 minutes of your time don't worry this
is really normal because this id and the
compiler behind it and really large
they're not like the gcc or the clan
llvm compilers that we just installed
okay so once you have this ticked or
checked you're going to click on
download or install whatever this button
is saying here this is going to install
both the microsoft visual studio ide
and the compiler from microsoft that you
can use directly to write c plus plus
applications so once we have this open i
am going to suppose that you have this
installed already i am going to close
out of this because i don't want to do
this
and you're going to have visual studio
installed on your system once you have
this installed you're going to come to
the start menu and say developer
and this is going to bring up two things
one is going to be the developer
powershell for visual studio 2019 and
the other is going to be a command
prompt it doesn't really matter what you
choose i am going to click on the
command prompt here
and once you do this this is going to
give you a terminal or a window through
which
the environment variables are already in
to start using the compiler from
microsoft and if we come here and type
cl.exe
we're going to see that we're going to
see the information here if this gives
you an error or something you're going
to know that you didn't really install
this properly so please go back and make
sure you have this installed if you have
a problem you can ask me i can do the
best i can to help you out but by this
moment we have three compilers on
windows that we can use for c plus plus
development we have the mingw or the gcc
compiler in our hands we have the klanga
lvm compiler and we have the compiler
from microsoft and now we can install an
ide or an editor and that's going to be
visual studio code and we can connect
that to these compilers so that we can
start writing our own z plus bus 20
applications we are going to head over
in the next lecture and install the
visual studio code editor
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture i am going to show
you how to install the visual studio
code editor on windows so if you are
watching this course on windows this
video here is going to be a must watch
we are going to head over to our search
engine and type visual studio code this
is going to give you a link where we can
download this cool editor if you want
you can learn all you can about it it is
a source code editor made by microsoft
it supports multiple languages but we're
going to be using that specifically for
c plus plus in the course here here i am
at the page for the editor and you can
read all you want about it but we are
interested in downloading this for
windows if you want you can click on
this download button here but i am just
going to scroll down
and have download links for windows if i
want i can click on user installer
system installer you can click on what
you want if you are on a 32-bit system
you're going to download a 32-bit
version i am just going to click on
64-bit here because i am on a 64-bit
operating system again
in this video we are doing this for
windows so this is going to be our area
of interest here i am going to click on
this download link and i am going to
wait for things to kick off
and i will have a window to start
downloading visual studio code setup
here i can save this file and it is
going to start downloading once it is
downloaded i am going to double click
and really click my way through this
until i have a visual studio code
installed on my computer here
okay the download is good i can crack
this open let's click on this
and you're going to see that it is
saying that it has detected that visual
studio code is already running on my
system because i have it installed but
if you don't have it installed you're
going to click your way through and
install this on windows and after you
have it you can start it
okay once you start visual studio code
you're going to have a window like this
if you run it for the first time you are
probably going to see a windows with
documentation and whatever
let's look at the welcome screen you're
going to probably see you're going to
probably see something like this but i
am not sure but the most important thing
is that you're going to have a window
like this with visual studio code the
first thing we want to do for c plus
plus development is going to scroll down
and click on this little thing that says
extensions i am going to click on this
and i am going to go in my search box
here and type c and c plus i can even
type c plus plus it doesn't really
matter and this is an area where we can
install extensions to make visual studio
code do all kinds of crazy things in
this case we are interested in making it
support c and c plus plus so we are
going to click on this extension that
says microsoft here cnc plus plus i am
going to click on this and if you don't
have it installed you can click on the
install button and it is going to
install this little thing and make your
computer ready to use visual studio code
for c plus plus so make sure you install
this and at the end it is going to say
disable or uninstall because it will be
already installed and enabled on your
computer and this is really the end of
our installation video for visual studio
code we are going to head over in the
next video and show you how you can make
a visual studio code use the compilers
that we installed in the previous video
so go ahead and finish up here and meet
me in the next lecture
in this video we're going to see how to
connect our visual studio code editor to
a compiler so that we can compile our
projects easily through the visual
studio code editor we already have the
ide installed from the last two previous
lectures when we have a compiler
installed in the last lecture we
installed the gcc compiler through the
mingw project we installed the clangela
vm compiler we even installed the
compiler from microsoft now we're going
to connect the ide to the compiler to
make it really easy to compile c plus
plus applications using these tools here
what i am going to do is really set up a
template project we're going to be
reusing throughout this course here so i
am going to go on a folder in my system
and i am going to right click on the
folder and say
open with visual studio code
let's do this this is going to open this
folder in visual studio code and i am
going to trust this folder here be
careful what you trust because some
things are going to do some malicious
things on your computer make sure you
trust the folders that you open up so i
am going to trust myself because i am
the creator of this folder here and this
is going to open visual studio code
now in our install video we installed
the c plus plus extension for visual
studio code again if you don't have this
installed please make sure you go back
and install and make sure this is saying
that this is enabled and now we want to
use this to write c plus plus
applications here we're going to write a
simple toy c plus plus application to
just test that our compilers support c
plus plus 20 and then we're going to use
this as a starting point or as a
template project so i want you to click
on this little plus icon here
and we're going to create a file called
main.cpp
and once you do that you will be able to
type c plus plus code in this year so we
are just starting out here i would
recommend to type this exactly as i do
here so we're going to say include and
say opening angle bracket and say io
stream
and we're going to go down here and say
and main
and we're going to go inside these curly
braces and say auto result and you are
going to exactly type what i tap here
don't worry we're going to have a chance
to learn about all these things here so
i am going to put a pair of parentheses
and i am going to say 10. and i am going
to put a weird operator here this is
called the spaceship operator it is just
something we can use to test that our
compiler supports it plus plus 20 and
we're going to put a 20 here and then
we're going to try and see if this is
greater than zero and we're going to
print this out we're going to say stdc
out again don't worry if you don't know
what this is this is just a way for us
to test and see if our compiler is going
to be able to use c plus plus 20. we're
going to say result here
and this is going to be our program now
we want to make sure we compile this
program so to bring in your compilers in
visual studio code all you have to do is
come to the terminal menu here so please
come here
and we're going to have
an option to configure tasks i want you
to click on this
and once you do this you're going to see
that visual studio code is going to find
the compilers that we just installed you
see that it has found
the
gcc compiler we installed in mingw you
see that it has found the clan compiler
i know about the g plus plus compiler
because you can see the path here you
can see c major w ben g plus plus dot
exe this is where we installed our g
plus plus compiler and i know about the
clank compiler because that's what's
being found here for example on this
entry here you see it says cmajw bin
clan plus plus so we wanted to configure
these two compilers here and later
visual studio could use them to build
our c plus plus 20 projects
now what we're going to do is click on
the g plus plus compiler first
and when we do that this is going to
create a tasks that json file in our
project and you see that it has created
a folder called dot vs code if i click
on my main cpp file here and do reveal
in explorer
this is going to open up on my system
and you see that this has created a dot
vs code folder and if we go and we're
going to find this tasks.json file this
is going to be our configuration to
configure which compilers that
visual studio code is using to compile
our main.cpp file here so if we go in
it's going to really have everything
ready for us so you're going to see that
it's going to be using our g plus plus
compiler this is the path to it and in
our args options here we have the
options that we pass to the compiler to
compile our program here now i want to
change this to say which kind of
compiler we are using
so we're going to change the level here
to say world width
g plus plus and say the version i think
that's going to be more descriptive here
so we're going to save world with g plus
plus or gcc
and we're going to say
11.2.0 because that's our version here
and the rest is really going to be
enough so let's try and see if we can
compile our program here and see the
thing here printing out
but
the other thing we need to do because
this program is using c plus plus 20 we
need to configure our compiler to use c
plus plus 20. and one way to do that in
gcc and you can really search these
things for example
if we come to our search engine here and
say configure gcc to use c plus plus 20
or even gcc
and say c plus plus 20. you can search
these things and find information and it
is a really good way to test your things
here
so let's see if we can find a link to
help out we have a stack overflow link
here so we can crack this open and if we
go and we're going to find a batch of
things for example we can say std c plus
plus 20 here as an option to our
compiler and this is going to bring
c plus plus 20 support in our gcc
compiler so i am going to copy this
and i am going to come back in my visual
studio code editor
and i am going to pass a flag to boiled
in c plus 20 mode and it is something i
just got from stack overflow here and we
are going to pass this to our compiler
and put a comma to make this a valid
configuration file and i am going to
close this
now once we have this open and we want
to build this we need to bring a
terminal window so we we're going to
bring the terminal window so that we can
see things happening and we do that by
coming to terminal and saying the new
terminal
and we will come back to terminal again
and say that we want to run a task in
this case we're going to be running our
world with gcc 1120 again if you are
using a newer version that's what you
should use and if we click on this thing
please make sure you have the main cpp
file selected before you do this so i
have this selected and i'm going to go
to run task and i am going to click on
this little thing you're going to see
that this is going to kick off the
process to build our program
and we're going to wait for this to
finish and you're going to see that it
is using c plus plus 20 here we're going
to see that the world finished
successfully and we have a main.exe file
created here so if we go in our terminal
in visual studio code and click enter
and
type clear and hit enter this is going
to clear the screen this is something
you can do to clear things out we can
run this main.exe binary directly here
so we're going to run exe here and if
you run it it's going to say zero and
this is an indication that we have our
visual studio code editor connected up
to our gcc compiler and we can use that
to compile c plus plus applications and
this is really the configuration with it
now you may ask how do i know this how
do i did i know the steps to follow to
get this to work
well if you come to extension tab here
and before we even do that i want to
bring to your attention that we have a
bunch of tabs here in visual studio code
we have a tab that says file i think the
one here saying explorer we have a one
we can use for version control if you
use something like git or whatever you
can use this but in this course we're
mostly going to be using the explorer
tab here and the
extensions tab to install things and at
a later time i will show you how to use
the debug tab here or run a debug tab
but in most cases we're going to be
using the explorer tab or the extensions
tab here if you want you can click on
this to close this so that you have some
more space you can click again to bring
this back these are some things you can
do in visual studio code but i am going
to show you how to configure your
compilers where i got the information so
click on extensions here
and we're going to find our cnc plus
plus extension
if we scroll down we're going to find
tutorials on how to set up this on
different compilers for example you can
crack this open
to see how to set up a visual studio
code to use your compiler from microsoft
if we come back we can see a link to see
how to use this with mingw on windows
let's click on this
and let's see what else we have we can
come back to here and we can see how to
use this with gcc on linux or clango on
a mac you can really choose whatever is
relevant for your operating system but
in this case here we are just using the
windows operating system so we're going
to see how to use this with the mingw
compiler that we just installed now we
can use the mingw compiler and i would
recommend reading up on this entire
thing to have an idea on what is
happening we already have our g plus
plus compiler so this is this command is
going to work again if we come back to
terminal here and run g plus plus
version i think we can see that we run
these commands here to see these things
working so we have this step here and if
you wonder what gdb is it is just a
debugger you can use to debug your
programs and again if we come to our
terminal here and say gdb
version we're going to have this
available from our mingw installation
you can see that we have this here so
this is working just fine you can really
follow this and configure your visual
studio code installation but i am just
showing you how to do this pretty fast
you can see that this is what we set up
in our configuration file which is our
tasks dot json file now one thing you
can do is modify the task.json file to
build every single file in your project
and this is something that is going to
make things easier what i'm going to do
is go back to our visual studio code
instance and find our project we're
going to crack open our tasks that json
file which is living in our dot vs code
folder
and i am going to take out the craziness
i have in my arguments here i am going
to select everything i am going to
delete that
and i am going to put in a configuration
that i am using for my projects here to
make this super easy what this is doing
it is telling the compiler to build in c
plus plus 20 mode it is going to tell
visual studio it is going to tell the
compiler to build every single cpp file
in our project so if we have multiple
files they are going to be built
together and we're going to specify the
name for our output file for example if
we don't want our binary executable to
be named mainly.exe we can give it a
name and i am going to be naming mine
rooster.exe in the course here i would
recommend doing the same so that we can
really have
the same habits as we go through the
course here but of course you are free
to use whatever you want in your c plus
plus programs here so once you have this
you can click save here and this is
going to save our json file here i can
close this
and i am going to bring my terminal by
going to view
and the terminal here this is going to
bring back my terminal that i had before
and i am going to run the clear command
and hit enter
and i am going to do dir to show the
contents
of my folder on windows here i wanted to
remove the main.exe file from the
terminal here so what i am going to do
is say rm
and i am going to say the name of the
file i want to remove i am going to say
main
dot exe and if i hit enter notice what
is going to happen the file is going to
go away i don't see it anymore here i
want to build again using my new
configurations in my tasks the json file
i am going to run the task to build with
our gcc compiler
this is going to build again and you see
that it is using the configurations that
i passed you see that it is building
every single cpp file in the directory
here and it is going to generate a
program called rooster.exe and we if we
look here we're going to find it we can
hit enter in the terminal
and we can type clear to clear things
out and if we do the ir again we're
going to see that we have rooster.exe
and we can run it by doing
rooster.exe here and this is going to do
what we want this is really all you need
to do to connect visual studio code to
your gcc compiler now we're going to
connect visual studio code to our clan
compiler that we have installed we
really want to be able to use it with
our project here and we're going to go
through the seven steps again so we're
going to go to terminal and say
configure tasks
and we're going to choose something that
says the clanger compiler and we're
going to find clang plus plus so let's
hunt for that i have something that says
that here we have
cloneplusplus.exe i am going to click on
that and if i do this this is going to
add an entry in my
tasks.json file so watch out for this i
am going to click on this
and let's crack this test that json file
open and you're going to see that this
is going to also set up another
configuration to world using my clang
plus plus compiler
and again i can edit this out a little
bit to say what we want let's look at
the version of cloud we have installed
to say that out this is going to be 12
1 so we're going to say world with clank
plus plus
12 0 1 let's say that here in our level
12.0.1 we can say that right here and
you see that it is really doing the same
thing we did with our gcc compiler so
what i can really do is still everything
i did in my gcc compiler i can
copy this
and i am going to take out the arguments
i have in my args here and i use what i
have in my gcc compiler you can see that
you can use the client compiler and the
gcc compiler in the same way and this is
something really cool so now we have the
option to use two compilers and this is
really cool so we're going to close the
json file and it's going to be saved
automatically
and we're going to bring up our terminal
window again
and let's bring this up a little bit and
we're going to do dir on windows and
we're going to remove the binary again
we're going to remove roster.exe
and again what you can do you can start
typing the name of the file you want to
remove and hit tab if you do that the
terminal is going to autocomplete this
for you and this is really cool so if i
do this the file is going to go away you
see that it is going right here
and i can clear
and what i am going to do is world with
the clan compiler can do that by coming
to terminal i am going to say that i
want to run a task and i am going to be
given an option i can either build with
gcc so if i choose gcc here it's going
to be used but i can also use clan let's
use clang here so i'm going to click on
this
and you're going to see that visual
studio code is going to kick off the
world process
this is going to build my binary
executable and notice that it is using c
plus plus 20 again the build is going to
finish successfully and i will have a
binary here and this is going to be all
i need to do so if i hit enter and run
my binary by tapping the name
and hitting tab this is going to
auto-complete if i run it it's going to
say zero and this is what we expect here
if you have some kind of error please
try and fix it if you have a problem you
can ask me and i will do the best i can
to help you out
okay now we have our two compilers
working we need to configure the
compiler from microsoft now the compiler
from microsoft is a little bit weird
again you can read up on this by coming
to your extension documentation
and going to using the compiler from
microsoft with visual studio code on
windows you can read up on all this if
you want but i am just going to show you
a quick way to get this running so the
compiler from microsoft is special in
that you have to specify the path to it
for example if we open a regular
terminal window and say
cl.exe to call the compiler
we're going to see that the terminal is
going to say that the
cl.exe compiler is not recognized and
the reason is we don't have the proper
environment variable settings for the
operating system to find this compiler
when we call it right here we are able
to use g plus plus and clan because we
put the environment variables in place
if you remember when we installed them
we did something like this we came to
the start menu and did env we came to
environment variables here and we put
the path
to our compilers in our environment
variables here you can see them right
here so we don't have the same thing for
the compiler from microsoft and that's
for a reason because we may have
multiple compilers installed from
microsoft
then if you have multiple compilers it
would be really cumbersome to choose
which compiler you want the guys at
microsoft opted for the option for you
the developer to specify which compiler
you want to run by coming to the start
menu here and typing developer
and choose which powershell for the
compiler you want to use for example if
we want to use the visual studio 2019
compiler we can click on this and then
we will have a terminal
that can run
the c plus plus compiler from microsoft
for example if we wait for this to be
ready and say cl.exe
we're going to see that we're going to
have a message saying that this is our
compiler we can use it however we want
so what we're going to do is set up a
terminal like this and use this terminal
to start visual studio code and the
visual studio code is going to start in
the mode
where it can find the compiler from
microsoft i know this is confusing but
please bear with me this is what we need
to do to get this to work if we start
visual studio code in a mode where it
knows about the environment variables
for the compiler from microsoft we will
have the ability to say cl.exe
and we will be able to use that right
here but you see that it is not
recognized now but we can use the g plus
plus compiler if we do this
version
we're going to see that it's available
we can use it we can use clan plus plus
and if we do version as well we're going
to see that we can use this little guy
here we also want the ability to use the
compiler from microsoft but to have
access to that we will have to close the
visual studio code instance we have here
and we're going to come back to our
project let's see if i can find it here
so we're going to go to the location
where we have our project and we're
going to change to the location of the
project here so i can grab the location
from my visual studio code project that
i just set up i am going to come back to
my powershell window that knows about
the path to the c plus plus compiler
from microsoft and i am going to change
it to the location of my project here so
i am going to say cd and paste in the
path i just copied and if i hit enter
this is going to change to my location
and i really recommend using powershell
if you have access to this because it is
a little more convenient to use it
supports more commands that you can use
in the command prompt but again that's
going to be your choice now i am in the
location for my project if i do ls or
dir
you can see that i can see my main cpp
file can see the binary we generated
earlier but this is not problem so what
i can do here is say code
and i say a dot and this is going to
start visual studio code in the current
folder of our project year so if you hit
enter we're going to wait for visual
studio code to come up it is going to
come up with the project we had in that
folder
and the special thing about
starting visual studio code this way is
that it's going to know about the
compiler from microsoft if we come back
to our terminal here
and clear and say cl.exe
you're going to see that now it knows
about the compiler from microsoft and we
can use it to do things so let's set
this up again if you want you can read
up on how to do this
on the documentation from visual studio
code itself but again i am going to show
you how to do this you can see that it
is really the same things they are doing
here so let's come back to visual studio
code and we're going to go to terminal
and we want to configure a task
now you see that we have the compiler
from microsoft available you can see
that we can use that right here so what
i am going to do is click on
cl.exe world active file
and this is going to add a new entry in
our configuration file and it is going
to open up if we go here we are going to
find that we have a command to build
using the compiler from microsoft so
let's change the level here and i say
world with msvc i think this is going to
be more descriptive and this is really
going to build your thing now i am going
to change this up so that it works
everything in the current folder
and again i am going to remove
everything here and put in a
configuration that i have ready on my
system here this is what i use for all
my projects again this is just calling
the compiler and giving it options to do
things we just need to specify that we
want to use the lattice standard of the
c plus plus standard and it is going to
specify
the input files we're going to be
building everything in the current
folder this is what we are saying here
and the output file is going to be
called rooster.exe
if we save this by saying ctrl s or
command s
and close our tasks dot json file we can
bring up our terminal window by going to
view and saying the terminal here
and we can go down and clear we can say
clear and hit enter
and if we do rm and say rooster and hit
tab this is going to remove the binary
we generated with the clang llvm
compiler earlier now we want to build
with the compiler from microsoft so
let's do this we're going to say
terminal and we're going to say that we
want to run a task but this time we want
to build with msvc this is what we want
to do here if we click on this little
thing we're going to kick off the
process to build with the compiler from
microsoft and we're going to wait for
the compiler to do its thing
and if we wait we're going to see that
the world finished successfully and if
we look in our folder we're going to see
that we have our output file and we can
come in our terminal and hit to enter
and do clear to clear things up and if
we say rooster just like this
and hit enter you're going to see that
it's going to say zero and this is
confirmation that we are able to use our
visual studio code editor and be able to
use it with all kinds of crazy compilers
and this is really cool if you are on
windows i recommend setting this up
because it's it's going to make it
easier to run a c plus plus applications
from visual studio code using
state-of-the-art compilers like msvc
clone and gcc here and this is really
cool now we have everything we need to
start running c plus plus applications
but before i let you go let's show you
how you can set this up so that you have
an easier time with regards to
intellisense and whatever so what we're
going to do we're going to go to our
view menu and we're going to choose
command palette
and in this we're going to say c or c
plus plus
we can say something like this and we're
going to choose edit configuration ui
this is going to give us an option to
configure things
and i want you to configure things your
new system
so i am on a windows system
let's see the options we have here i am
only going to have the option for win32
but if we go down we can specify
the things we need
visual studio code configured for for
example it's going to give us
intellisense or autocomplete and all
kinds of greater things using the
setting we choose here if we want we can
choose the gcc compiler or whatever i am
just going to leave in the windows msvc
compiler because i am on windows here
but know that you can configure these
things now if we go down we're going to
see that we have the option to configure
the c plus plus standard and the
compiler path that is going to be used
to figure things out we're going to be
using the compiler from microsoft here
but know that you have the option to
choose any other compiler for example we
can choose the g plus plus compiler we
can choose the clank plus class compiler
you can configure these things and if
you need to change this please come back
here and do these configurations here
we're going to leave in this whole
intellisense and what we will do
is configure visual studio code to use
the c plus plus 20 standard so we're
going to do that right
here and if you set this up you're going
to see that visual studio code is going
to generate a cpp properties
file which is going to store all these
configurations here so it is really
going to be
a configuration for what we choose in
our configuration here so make sure you
choose what makes sense again i would
recommend using c plus plus 20 but if
you go on top you can really use any
compiler you want i am going to use the
compiler from microsoft this is okay i
am going to use windows msvc
configuration for intellisense here and
i am going to close this and we are
really ready to start using visual
studio code to ride c plus plus
application so let's clean this up a
little bit we're going to view our
terminal and we're going to remove the
junk that was generated by the compiler
from microsoft i am going to say rm and
say rooster
and i can remove the binary i can say rm
and say rooster and say tab this is
going to autocomplete and really remove
things i don't need i am going to remove
the pdb file i am going to remove
rooster
you know i am going to remove the main
object file so let's say main dot obj
and i am going to remove main dot
or vc we don't want to remove our cpd
file so now we have a project we can use
as a starting point to write c and c
plus plus applications here so what we
will be doing in the next few lectures
or the next few chapters is reusing
this thing here as a template project so
what i can do is uh call this
c plus plus 20 template project and
let's do this here i think i need to
close video studio code otherwise it's
going to complain so i am going to call
this little guy c plus plus 20 template
project and
later when we start learning about c
plus plus proper we're going to be using
this as a starting point and we want to
have to reconfigure the compilers our
project will be ready to use
the compilers that we set up here namely
the compiler from microsoft the g plus
plus compiler and the clang plus plus
compiler and that's going to be really
cool this is really all i have to share
in this lecture i hope you have visual
studio code set up to use all these
compilers we are going to stop here in
this lecture the next one we're going to
start and see how to set up your
development environment on linux and
we're going to start by installing
compilers on ubuntu 2004
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to see
how to install c plus plus compilers on
linux we are going to be working on an
ubuntu 2004 system and we will install a
new version of gcc and the latest
version i can get my hands on for clang
llvm so let's do this okay so here i am
on my linux box this is ubuntu 2004 if i
do you name and say a
we're going to see the information on
this
and you will have to adapt this for
whatever linux distribution you are on
and to install gcc it's really simple
but the problem is the latest version of
gcc at the time of recording this video
is gcc 11 and it's not available in the
ubuntu packages now for example if you
do see do
apt get install
gcc 11
this is how you get it
if you do this
you're going to put in your password
you're going to see that this is really
not available yet right we cannot find
this so the best version we can install
is gcc 10 which i happen to have
installed already on this system so
we're going to do gcc 10 that's what
we're going to install here
and if we do this we're going to see
that this is already available you can
also install g plus plus done i think
you can do that
okay so we're going to run the command
here and we're also going to see that
it's already available here but if you
don't have these
they are going to be installed and you
can use them on your linux system
another tool that is necessary on linux
is the gdb debugger so we're going to do
sudo apt
get install
gtb
right if you install it it's going to be
installed but i already have it
installed already so now if i do gcc 10
on my system here and say version we're
going to see the version printed out we
can do g plus plus stand we can see the
version here let's do that for c plus
plus
so we're going to see the version here
we can even do gdb version
and it is going to show up let's wait
for this we're going to see my gdp
version here and now i can use these
compilers to compile c plus plus code on
my linux box here so this completes our
steps to install a gcc compiler on linux
we're going to look at how we can get a
hold of the clang compiler
on our linux box here and it is really
simple all you have to do is to do
apt get install
and we're going to install clang 12
because that's the latest version at the
time of recording this video if we do
this we're going to see that it's going
to install i already have it installed
here but if you don't have it installed
it's going to install on your system and
this is going to give you all the tools
you need to compile with the clan
compiler on this particular ubuntu
system these installs are going to be
installed in my user bin directory so if
i see the there and do analysis to show
everything in here
and scroll up we're going to find all
the versions for clan you see i have
multiple versions clang 10 11 12
and we have clan plus plus variance of
this i think we do okay we have clank
plus plus and clan here and this is
going to do what we want we have the
clan combiner and the gcc compiler
installed on our system here now if you
want to get the latest version of gcc
installed on your system
one easy way i found is to go through a
package manager called homebrew let's
search for this
right if you search for this you're
going to find it and if you want you can
install it on your linux system
and when you install it it's going to to
be basically there ready to use
and to install it i think there's a
command there install home brew
let's do this install here and if we do
install
we should find a link to install this
let's find a link i think they have a
link you can copy aha it is this little
thing here you can copy it paste it in
your terminal and it is going to install
home brew on your system
and when you have home brew installed
you can go through it to install the
latest version of gcc for example if we
search for homo blue
gcc in our search engine here
we're going to find all the information
to install this through home brew and
you just have to do bro install gcc and
this is going to install this on your
system and you're going to see that it
is going to install the latest version
at the time of recording this video so
this is what you should do for example
if we go back to our linux box we can do
let's cd into our home directory and
we're going to say brew
install gcc
and it's going to tell me that it is
already installed because i installed
this
but if you don't have it installed it's
going to install it and you do this
after you have gone through the steps
to install
the home brew package manager on your
system and you do that by just copying
this link and pasting that in your
terminal and hitting enter and it's
going to give you directions on what you
can do to get this properly installed on
your system here so this is really cool
so if you want the absolute latest
version in gcc this is one way you have
to get a hold of it without really going
through the complex steps to build the
compiler yourself on linux okay it is
taking some more time here i am just
going to kill this because i already
have the latest version of gcc here if i
do jcc 11 on linux and the do version
i am going to see that i have 11 2 and
it was installed through homebrew and if
you let this run to completion it's
going to install this on your computer
we don't have to wait for this so now we
have the latest version of gcc on an
ubuntu system we also have the latest
version of clan this completes our
tutorial on how to set up compilers on
linux we are going to stop here in this
lecture this one we're going to install
visual studio code on the linux system
and then in the next one we're going to
link visual studio code to these
compilers and be able to use visual
studio code type code and compile our
programs using these two compilers here
so go ahead and finish up here and meet
me in the next lecture
in this lecture we're going to see how
to install the visual studio code editor
on a linux system and again we will be
working on our ubuntu 2004 system here
so let's head over to the website for
visual studio code and download our
binary and install it on our linux
system here okay so here we are at the
website for visual studio code you can
get there by searching for visual studio
code in your search engine and you're
going to land here and all we really
have to do
is go down to find our download links
we're going to see that for debian and
ubuntu we can download here but you can
also find something specific to other
distribution okay so we are going to
grab the 64-bit version of debian ubuntu
here because that's my system and you're
going to find whatever makes sense for
your distribution so let's grab this
here we're going to grab the link so if
you click on this
this is going to kick off the download
process and you will see this downloaded
on your system and once you have this
downloaded you're going to install it
and in ubuntu you can just double click
on this to install it or you can install
it like you install any debian package
on a linux system for example if you are
unsure on how to install debian packages
all you have to do is do a simple search
so let's do google.com and go there and
we're going to see how to install
to install debian
packages
on ubuntu
2004 so this is our version here and
you're going to find a lot of
instructions on how to do this it's
going to be really simple so we can go
down and find a way to install so all
you have to do is says you do dpkga
say i and you pass the name of the
package and this is going to install
visual studio code on your system once
you do this you will have visual studio
code installed and you will be ready to
start it and use it on your system here
once it is installed you will have the
ability to come in your system here for
example and say code dot and this is
going to open a visual studio code
instance on your system let's wait for
this to come up so that you really see
this
okay so this is going to open visual
studio coordinate system and you can
start using it like we will do in the
next lecture okay once you have a visual
studio code installed and started up on
your linux system the very first thing
you need to do
is to install the extension that is
going to allow you to do some c and c
plus plus and to do that you will come
to this tab here that says extension and
in our search box you can start typing c
and c plus plus
and you are going to have an entry that
says microsoft here so please select
this and this is going to be the
extension you need to install you're
going to click on install and it is
going to install
and this is what enables a visual studio
code to do some c plus plus programming
and this is really cool if you want you
can check out how to use it on linux and
you're going to have instructions on how
to do this but we will do this in the
next lecture and show you how to
configure visual studio code to use the
compilers that we have installed in a
previous lecture so we're going to tell
visual studio code to use our client
compiler we're going to tell it to use
our gcc compiler and we will have the
flexibility to come to terminal and
choose which compiler we want to use and
we're going to do all this in the next
lecture so go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to configure
our visual studio code editor to use the
compilers that we just installed in a
few previous lectures so we will be able
to type our code in our visual studio
code editor just like we do here and we
will pass the code through the compiler
to generate a binary that can in turn
run on our linux system here this is
what we want to do so we want visual
studio code to use the compilers that we
installed so let's head over to our
linux box and do this okay here i am on
my linux box this is the current
directory where i am at this is where i
am going to do my things here so i am
going to create a folder and call it a
template project let's do this we're
going to say
mkdir and we're going to say c plus plus
20 template project i think this is
going to do
or we can even say cpp because i'm not
sure the plus signs here are not going
to give us a problem let's play it on
the safe side and we are going to create
this folder and we're going to cd into
this folder
okay once we are in this folder we're
going to open this folder in visual
studio code and the easiest way to do
that
once you have visual studio code
installed is just to type code and type
dot
and you will basically be telling the
operating system to open visual studio
code in the current folder here so i am
going to hit enter
and this is going to kick it open and i
trust this folder because i just created
it and we are in our project here the
very first thing we're going to do is to
create a main cpp file so let's do that
and i did that by clicking on the plus
icon here
and i typed in the name of the file and
i am going to put in some dummy code
here that we want to use our starter
code we're going to say
iostream and we're going to put in our
code here we're going to say main and
again you don't have to type all this if
you want you can get the code from the
resource section on the lecture so you
can copy the code paste that in here and
be on your merry way because we haven't
really started learning about c plus
plus we are setting up the environment
so don't stress yourself here
this is just some simple code to test
our compilers to see if they support c
plus plus 20 because we want to use the
letter standard we can get our hands on
here so let's do equals
type exactly what i typed here so we're
going to say 10
and we're going to put this weird
operator and say 20 and we want to see
if this
madness here is greater than zero this
is what we want to do and we're going to
say stdc out and the same result okay so
type exactly what i type here and as we
progress in the course we're going to
make sense of all these madness we see
here so now that we have a cpp file
containing the code for our c plus plus
program we want to compile this and we
need to tell visual studio code which
compiler it's going to use to compile
this program here to give us a binary
that we can run so what we're going to
do is come to terminal here
and we're going to say that we want to
configure tasks
and the task is really a set of
instructions you give to visual studio
code on how to take your c plus plus
project and turn that into a binary that
can run on that system here so that's
what we want to do we want to tell
visual studio code which compiler it's
going to use we're going to configure
task here and you're going to see that
it's going to discover many compilers on
my system here you see we have clan 10
clang 11 clan 12 and we should also have
gcc 11 if we keep scrolling down we're
going to find these little guys here i
have many compilers on this system so i
am going to choose
the
gcc compiler
which is installed through home brew
this is what i'm going to choose here
you say it's saying g plus plus 11 but
if you have access to g plus plus 10 you
can also use that it's going to work
with what we want to do in this course
here mostly so i am going to choose the
best i have in terms of gcc
and this is going to set up an entry in
our tasks dot json file to build and run
this program here and that's what we're
going to do okay you see it is using
this particular compiler and one thing
we can do before we try and build this
we can change the level here to make it
a little bit
more descriptive so we're going to save
world
with gcc
11.2.0 if i am correct
and this is all we can save this
and we can close this json file and if
we bring up a terminal window we can do
that by hitting terminal here and
choosing a new terminal
this is going to open up the current
location for example if we do pwd in
this terminal here let's use lowercase i
think that's what it wants we're going
to see the location here this is my
project so to build i can come to
terminal
and i choose run task and i am going to
choose the task to compile with my gcc
installation here if i choose this
it is going to kick off the weld process
and you're going to see that the
gibberish i have here is not supported
because the
compiler is not configured to use the c
plus plus 20. so all we really need to
do is go back to our command and tell it
to use c plus plus 20. and we can do
that by passing a specific instruction
to the compiler to use c plus plus 20
like we do on line 10 here so we're
going to say std equals c plus plus 20.
we are going to save this a little bit
and i really wanted you to see this
problem here because many people are
going to forget this and we're going to
try and build again making sure we are
selecting the main cpp file here so
let's go to terminal run task and use
our compiler
and wait for it to do its thing you're
going to see that the world now finished
successfully
and if we come back to our terminal here
and do ls we're going to see that we
have a file called main
and if we run it we should see a zero so
let's say main here
and if we run it we're going to see a
zero meaning that our program is running
and working correctly we are able to
compile a c plus plus project on a linux
system here now if you want to see how i
came up with the information to use the
tax json file please come back to the
extensions tab here
and choose the c and c plus plus
extension we're going to click on this
and we're going to see all the
instructions on how to use this guy on
the linux system here so gcc on linux we
can choose this
and we're going to see all the
information here now you can read up on
all this if you want but what i am going
to do is go to visual studio code and
show you exactly what you need to do to
get this to work what i want to do in
there is set this up to compile
everything in my what i want to do is to
set what i really want to do is to what
i really wanted to do is to set this up
so that it compiles every single cpp
file in my directory here and i can do
that by putting in
a set of instructions i had prepared
beforehand
so we're going to tell it to compile in
c plus plus 20 mode we're going to tell
it to compile every single cpp file in
this directory and then we're going to
specify the output file name for our
binary now this is code i used on
windows i need to adapt it to be
specific to linux
so
let's see what they say in the
documentation there and we can
we can scroll down a little bit and
we're going to see that they use
backslashes here so that's what we're
going to use in visual video code to
play it safe so we can say this
a backslash and this is a backslash
and we will try and build this and we're
going to see what happens here this is
going to build our project in c plus
plus 20 mode we're going to be building
every single cpp file in the project and
the output will be called rooster this
is what we want to do here let's save
this up
and i am going to close this json file
and i will bring up my terminal by
coming to view and save a terminal here
and i can remove the main.exe file or
the main executable i had in there if i
do lsuc it's gone but now if we try and
compile with the gcc compiler
we're going to see what happens you see
the world is good and we have a binary
called rooster and we can run it here if
we do rooster we're going to see it run
and give us a zero and this is really
all we need to do now we have this
working for
our gcc compiler but we wanted the same
for a clanger compiler and we want the
flexibility to be able to switch
compilers by coming here and just
selecting the right task so let's do
this we're going to configure clan we're
going to come to terminal we want to
configure a task and we're going to
choose the best we have in terms of
clang that happens to be clang
plus plus 12 here so we're going to
choose this and this is going to add an
entry in our
tasks.json file we're going to change
this to say that we want to build with
clan let's do that we're going to say
world with clang
i think we have
12.0.1 if i remember correctly but we
can ask
our terminal here let's go to terminal
and we're going to say clang plus plus
and 12 that's the version and we're
going to ask it what's your version it's
going to tell us in detail and if we
wait we're going to see this speed out
on the terminal here and this happens to
be clank version 1200
so that's what we're going to say in our
file here
weld with clan 12 0 0
to be super clear on this
and uh this is really all all we need to
do is put in the instructions
to build in c plus plus 20 mod exactly
what we did for gcc here so i am going
to copy this and put that in my
arguments here i'm i am going to take
out whatever i had in there i am going
to put in my new things and let's see if
this compiler works now we're going to
save our tasks.json file and come back
to the cpp file we're going to bring up
our terminal window
and we're going to clear
and remove rooster because we wanted to
build a new one with our clank compiler
and we will come to terminal run task
now we're going to choose to build with
clang 12.0 we're going to fix this in a
minute but if we do this we're going to
see that our weld process is going to
start it's going to be building with our
clan compiler it's going to be using c
plus plus 20. it's going to be building
every single cpp file in this location
here and the output of the world will be
a binary called rooster that we have
right here so the build is good if we do
ls we're going to find rooster and if we
run it it's going to say zero exactly as
we expect here and we have visual studio
code properly configured to use our two
compilers the client compiler and the
gcc compiler let's come back to our
configuration and change this to say
12.0.0
to be super clear on the version we have
we can close our json file here
and come and try to build again if we do
terminal and run task we will have our
compiler here ignore all these things i
think visual video code is going to give
you duplicates but you can choose
the version that says what you want and
it is going to work so we're going to
choose gcc oh we are saying gcc but we
want clang here so let's say that we
want to build with clan we're going to
go to terminal
and run task
and we want clang
12.0.0 this is right here so we're going
to select it
and it's going to build successfully and
we will have our binary here if we run
it
it is going to say zero and this is
really what we need to do here so this
is really all i had to share in this
lecture showing you how you can
configure
visual studio code to compile using the
compilers that we have installed another
thing you can do to make your experience
better is come back to view and select
command palette here and you can do c
and the c plus and edit the
configurations through a user interface
and if we do this you're going to see
that this is going to create a cpp
properties json file so this is where we
can configure
what kind of intelligence what kind of
what kind of compiler is going to be
used we can do all these things here so
we're going to leave it to the default
it's on our linux system it's going to
be using gcc 11 which is the best we
have
in terms of gcc
but uh one thing you should note in this
course here is the c plus plus standard
we wanted to use so we wanted to use z
plus plus 20 and we want visual studio
code to give us intellisense
or
format our main cpp file based on the c
plus plus 20 standard year that's what
we can achieve with this so once you
have this and
you can come and close this
and if we go back to the main cpp file
you see now
that this is no longer flagged as a
problem with squiggly lines visual
studio code is properly understanding
what is happening here and this is
something you can do to make your
experience a little bit better
okay now that we have this project set
up and ready on linux we're going to be
reusing this as a template project every
time we start something new on linux so
every time we want to create a new
project we will grab this entire folder
so for example we will come to our
terminal here and go up a little bit
so cd and go up one level and if we do
ls we're going to have our c plus plus
20 template project we will copy it and
rename it to start a new project and
that's going to give us all the
configuration that we did we don't need
to reconfigure the compilers or whatever
it is going to work right out of the box
and that's really what we did here we
set up a template project that we will
be reusing all over again in the course
as we progress learning about c plus
plus 20. i am going to stop here in this
lecture the next one i am going to show
you how you can set up a development
environment on the mac os system
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this video i am going to show you how
to install c plus plus compiler on your
mac os system and we have a bunch of
options on the mac we can install the
gcc compiler we can install the clang
version
of the apple company or we can install
the clangle vm version all these are
options and i will show you how to
install these i don't have access to a
mac device so i won't really be able to
install xcode and show you but i think
you can manage if you are using a mac
system it is nothing complicated you
just have to go to the apple store and
click on xcode and it is going to
install for a gcc and clang llvm i will
show you how to do this using the
homebrew package manager which is also
going to make this super easy okay so
let's head over to our browser and we
have a good link here from digitalocean
on how to install and use homobrew on a
mac os system this is a really validated
link you can see that right here and you
can read up on this if you are using a
mac system i am going to share the link
here in the resources section of the
course and to use this we will go
through the mac os terminal and it is
nothing complicated you can search for
it and open it up and after you do this
you will have to install the tools
needed to build things on the mac os
system and that's going to install xcode
here so grab the command here and run it
in your terminal and this is going to
install everything you need and after
you have this installed you're going to
install home brew i do recommend coming
up to the website here for homebrew and
clicking on this copy icon here this is
going to copy the entire thing and you
can copy this
and once you copy it it is going to give
us a green tick here
and you can go in the terminal on your
mac os system i am using a linux
terminal here and then you're going to
paste this command in here and hit enter
once you do that you will be prompted to
put in the password it's going to tell
you that it needs to install homebrew
and you are basically going to wait for
this to finish i have to warn you this
is going to take some time even if you
have a good internet connection this is
going to take some time so be patient
here when it's done it's going to tell
you that it is finished and you will be
ready to install the gcc compiler and
the client llvm compiler through your
homebrew installation here i am not
going to click on this because
i already have this installed on my
linux system here let's go back to the
link and see what they say next so after
you paste that in it's going to install
and after that you will see that
homebrew is going to be installed on
your system
and uh
you can use home brew to start
installing and upgrading packages you
can really read up on this but what i
want you to see
is that you can use home brew to install
the gcc compiler and the clang ll vm
compiler so if we come to the search
here and say gcc homo
broom we're going to find instructions
on how to install this so all you need
to do really is to say brew install gcc
this is going to install the latest
version of gcc on your mac
if we come here and say llvm or clank
let's say clan
and
we can find that right here llvm
and it is going to give us instructions
on how to install this and all you have
to do
is brew install llvm and this is going
to install these two compilers on your
mac system so once you do that you will
have them stored somewhere let's go to
the install link and we're going to see
that homebrew is basically going to be
installed into things in your user local
directory on a mac device please tell me
if this is true for your case and if you
have a problem we'll try and go through
that and fix that up so if you are on a
mac i would really recommend going
through this to install homebrew once
you have that installed you will go
through that to install both of the llvm
compiler and the gcc compiler and that's
going to give you the latest versions
for these compilers to find out if they
will installed you can go in your user
local directory and you can hunt through
these compilers and you're going to find
binaries for them and start using them
to build your c plus plus applications
you okay so by now i am going to
consider that you have both gcc and a
clang installed on your mac system the
next logical thing to do is to want the
apple version of clang and i think
that's going to come as part of xcode
here
and it is going to come as a result of
running the command that we did before i
think it was this little command here
which is going to install everything you
need from the
xcode
ide so this is all i have to share in
this lecture again i apologize i don't
have access to a mac device but if you
have a problem you can tell me and i
will try to help you out and get this
sorted out
we are going to stop here in this
lecture the next one we're going to see
how we can install xcode on your mac
device go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this video i am going to show you how
to install the visual studio code editor
on your mac os system please know that
you can also use other ides like x code
or code lite do c plus plus development
but visual studio code is going to be
our main editor in this course here and
i would recommend to install it so that
we are doing consistent things that's
going to reduce chances for you to get
confused so we are going to head over to
the website for visual studio code
and to get there we can just type visual
studio code in here on in our search
engine and we will have a link here that
we can use to download our fans
so we are going to go down and find
download links for windows linux and mac
please use the mac download button here
and you're going to download the binary
and install it i think it is going to be
in the download folder by default so all
you have to do
is drag that up in your installation
directory so that it becomes a runnable
application after you do that you're
going to run it and it is going to run
and you will have a user interface like
this with visual studio code opened up
once you have that up you will need to
install the c plus plus extension and
what you need to do is come to the
extensions tab here and type c and c
plus plus in here and you're going to
have an entry for microsoft click on
that and install this extension on your
system and your visual studio code
instance is going to be ready to handle
some c plus plus development and this is
really all i had to share in this
lecture showing you how you can get this
installed again i apologize i don't have
access to a mac device so i used my
linux box running inside window
subsystem for linux to show you this but
this is good enough i think if you have
a problem you can tell me and i will do
the best i can to help you out for now
we're going to stop here in this lecture
in the next one i will try and show you
how to set up a visual studio code to
use the compilers that we installed in
the last lecture
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture i am going to try and
show you how to configure visual studio
code to use the compilers that we
installed on our mac system in a
previous lecture so we want visual
studio code to be able to pick up our
gcc compiler and use it we want it to
pick up our client compiler and use it
we also wanted to pick up our clanger
compiler from apple and use it to build
binaries that we can then run on our
system here so let's see how to do this
i have to say i don't own a mac device
so the best i can do here is describe
the process to you and if you have a
problem you can tell me i will do the
best i can to help you out okay so once
you have visual studio code installed
you're going to create a folder
somewhere and open visual studio code
from that folder and what you will
basically do is use the terminal to
navigate to a location you're going to
create a folder you can even call it cpp
template project you're going to hop
over into that folder and then open
visual studio code from that folder here
so for example we can hop over into cpp
and run code and say dot that's going to
open visual studio code in that folder
and from that folder you will create a
main cpp file by clicking on the plus
button here and you will create the cpp
file call it main cpp and you can put in
the content here and once you have this
the next task is going to be to set up a
compiler to build this little thing so
once you have this project you will come
to terminal i think there's going to be
a terminal menu somewhere and you will
choose configure tasks once you do that
visual studio code is smart enough to
scan your system and find any compiler
you have installed the first thing that
is likely to be found is the apple
client compiler so you're going to find
a clone
plus plus compiler so you can choose
that and you can use that for the apple
client compiler we are lucky we even
have a tutorial on how to do that so if
we click on our extensions tab here and
choose our c and c plus plus
extension
if we scroll down we're going to see a
link on using the client on mac os here
this is going to give us all the
instructions we need to use visual
studio code with the client compiler
from the apple company so if you scroll
down you're going to be able to read up
on all this but what i really want you
to see is the configuration file you're
going to see that it's going to be using
the clang compiler from the user bin
directory and this is mostly going to be
the clang version from the apple company
and sometimes you don't want this so if
you want to use the clang version that
we installed through home brew i think
you will need to go through the user
local directory because that's where
homebrew is going to put it you're going
to see that that's going to be the
location here from our tutorial and
you're going to hunt down for the clan
compiler and find your binary and that's
what we're going to be using next but
for the first time if you want to use
the clan compiler from apple this is the
configuration you need and all you need
to do in this case is change this to c
plus plus 20.
now once you have this configured you
will have the ability to come to
terminal let's show our files here you
terminal and run task and choose the
compiler that's going to be the clang
compiler from apple but you can also
configure other compilers and all you
really have to do is choose them in the
list here and you're going to have a
configuration file it tasks
json file to be exact let's show that up
here
and that's going to give you the
instructions you need to build this
and in most cases you will just need to
be careful about the path to the
compiler so for example if you are using
the gcc version you installed through
homo brew you're going to find that in
your location you're going to make sure
that's the correct one and you will put
in these instructions here to tell your
compiler to build every single cpp file
in the directory here this is what we do
if you use clan you're going to have
something like this and again i am
describing this to you because i don't
have a mac available to me right now
and if you have a problem you can tell
me we can try and sort this out okay and
by this time you will have the ability
to use your visual studio code instance
and compile
c plus plus programs using either the
apple client compiler the llvm glango
compiler or the gcc compiler and all
these are going to be compiling in c
plus plus 20 mode again to both you need
to make sure you have the file selected
and choose whatever compiler you want to
use for example if you want to use clone
12 from homebrew you're going to you're
going to select that and it is going to
be used to build your project and you
will have the ability to run your
projects just like we do here and it is
going to work let's make sure we are
running rooster here our binary
and it is going to run and printer 0 and
this is going to work again i am really
sorry i don't have a mac device
available to me
but this is what i have to work with now
if you have a problem on a mac device
please tell me i will do the best i can
to help you out
in this lecture we're going to explore
the option to use online compilers if
for whatever reason we can't install a
radio compiler on our system and again
the goal is to be able to turn the code
we type into what looks like an ide
into a compiler and get a binary that we
can run and see the output of there are
a few online compilers that are very
popular within the c plus plus community
one box is one of them there is also
compiler explorer and kodiro but there
may be other ones out there if you do
research on your own we're going to go
to the browser and actually check each
of these out okay here we are in our
browser here i am on onebox.org
and you see that it really looks like an
ide inside we have the code we've been
running all along to make sure that it
compiles with c plus plus 20. on the
left here we have a few options we can
select which compiler we want to use you
see that there is a couple of gcc
versions
you can see that this is a really nice
way to test things across
gcc versions you see we have clan 12
so if you want to test clang out you can
select it let's actually try this
so we're going to use clang head
and try to compile this
so let's hit enter and see if clank 12
supports c plus plus 20
and you see that it really works clan
version 12
should support c plus plus 20 like this
let's go back to
gcc because that's what i like and you
can try putting different things in your
c plus plus code to see if the compiler
actually responds for example we can say
stdcl
hello there
stdendl
and if we run
we're going to see
the message output here another good
thing with these online compilers is
that you can share this code and anybody
will be able to look at the code here
and run it so this is a really good way
to
get help from your instructor so i do
encourage you if you run into a problem
come and use one of these compilers and
send me the link the way you can send
the link you can hit on share here this
button here you're going to get the url
that you can copy and send to anybody
and they will be able to see your code
just like we're going to see here in a
minute okay you see that it isn't the
exact same thing and anybody on the
internet will be able to see your code
and try to find whatever the problem is
and help you out
very fast one box is one compiler you
can play with the options that we have
here you can
load different libraries you see they
have a lot of boost libraries but this
is of no interest to us right now you
can play with it and see what you like
about it another one is kaliru which is
another online compiler you see it
doesn't have a lot of options like we
had in one box for example you cannot
change the compiler it's going to be
using g plus plus but if we hit compile
link and run it's going to run our code
and we're going to get the output here
again we can try and change this so that
you know i'm not lying to you so we can
say stdcl
and say the sky
is blue
std endl if you want you can hit control
plus on your browser and it's going to
make this a little bigger
and if we compile link and run
we should see the sky is blue in the
output window here this is really all
you can do with kolero and if you like
it you can donate to the developers i
think we have the same thing
on one box but it is in japanese so i
can't really read this
okay another one is compiler explorer
which is a really good one the main
purpose of this is really not giving you
the output it is actually seeing
assembly code that is generated for your
c plus plus code this is something a
little bit advanced for our purposes
here so we're going to ignore this we're
just going to be using it to test our
code with some of the popular compilers
if you look here on this drop box you
see that they also have a lot of
compilers you can use different gcc
compilers i think they have clan they
even have msvc how cool is this so you
can use a lot of compilers gcc clang you
see we have a lot of clan compilers we
have clang
11 here so this is a really good way to
try things out we're going to come back
to gcc
10 2
and i noticed that i passed the flag of
c plus 20 to be able to support c plus
plus 20. again if i come here in my code
and say stdc out
the sky
is white
don't worry about these errors they're
going to go away in a minute
let's wait for the program to compile
you see that it is compiling let's wait
a minute the sky is white and everything
is fine
if you don't see this output here it is
possible that you didn't check this
checkbox run the compiled output
so come to this
dropbox and make sure this is checked
and you should have a window like i have
here compiler explorer also allows you
to share your code with people on the
internet
let me see if i can find the option to
share
you come to this drop box and you get a
link here that you can copy
i'm going to copy this
and open a private window in my browser
here so that we know that it is some
other
browser that is going to be opening this
link and getting access to the same code
we have in compiler explorer and this is
going to be pretty cool
and you see that we get compiler
explorer privacy we're going to close
this
and you see that we have the same code
we can try modifying this code for
example we can take out this third line
here it's going to start compiling you
see that it is compiling and it is going
to give us the output that we expect
from this so this is a really good tool
to try out if you want to share your
code with some people that are not close
to you this is a really good way to do
this it is also good to try out
different compilers for example if you
don't have a gcc compiler you can try it
out here and see if it does things for
example we didn't install clang on our
system but we can try it out and see if
it runs or could but make sure you pass
the correct flats here because you are
responsible for this if you pass the
flats that don't work
you're going to get arrows for example
if we say hello here
we're going to get
weird arrows
and oh and recognize command line option
std hello but if we say c plus plus 20
it is going to work so make sure you
pass the correct options
in this lecture you're going to write
your first c plus 20 program and we're
going to start and attempt to understand
our program let's hop over to visual
studio code and actually do that the
first thing we want to do is to set up
our code so that we can open that in
visual studio code we're going to start
from our c plus 20 template project that
we set up in the last lecture
and i'm going to be doing the projects
for this chapter in this folder here so
we're going to do our very first c plus
plus program so what we're going to do
is go inside our c plus plus 20 template
project
and i noticed that we actually left in
the boiled files we don't want so
what we're going to do is remove this
main file
and that this vc 140 fan we don't want
these here
and we're going to copy
the main cpp file and the dot vs code
folder we're going to copy these things
and we're going to put them in our first
c plus plus program folder
and we're going to open this folder in
visual studio code visual studio code is
not opened up you see that i have my
developer powershell opened if you want
you can open visual studio code directly
without going through this if you're not
going to be using the visual studio
compiler but i want to have the option
to use that compiler so this is how i am
going to open my visual studio code
instance i am going to type
code.exe
to open this up i'm going to hit enter
and visual studio code is going to open
and it is going to open whatever we did
in the last lecture we don't want this
project because this is a template
project from the last chapter we're
going to close this folder go to file
and hit
close folder and we're going to open the
new folder we want to work on we're
going to go to file and hit open folder
we're going to go to the location where
our project is so you're going to go
where yours is i'm going to browse to
mine
and i'm going to go in the current
chapter and choose 3 2 first c plus plus
program
i'm going to select the folder
it's going to open up and you're going
to see that our settings from
the last template project are still
valid here they were copied over if we
open the main cpp file it's going to be
the main thing we had in the last
lecture
so
we have the option to run task you're
going to see that we have two compilers
available and this is really good we are
ready to start using this let's try and
build this with gcc
and we're going to have our binary
created
we can click in the terminal here
and if we want to open the terminal
again we have the option to come in
terminal and new terminal this is going
to open this up if we do dir in the
terminal
we're going to see our program generated
we can remove this thing here and say rm
rooster
dot exe and remove this we can clear
and we have a clean project we can start
learning from okay now we have the
project and it is building successfully
let's try to understand the code we have
in here the first statement we have it
this include io stream thung
this is a feature c plus plus offers to
load the pro built libraries that we can
use iostream is specifically going to
help us print thanks to the console
we've seen that we can for example print
hello world
if we want
let's take out all these things in here
and say std column column c out
this is coming from i iostream and we're
going to put two less than symbols we're
going to open two quotes and inside
we're going to type hello world
and we're going to go outside the quotes
and do two less than signs and say std
colon colon endl
and put a semicolon this is going to
print things on the console if we run
this program
so if we run this program the first
thing we need to do is to build this
program so we can come to terminal task
and we're going to build it with gcc and
after we've built it we can hit enter to
close the terminal
and we can do dirt to see the content of
the folder you see that a program has
been generated we can run it and if we
run it it's going to say hello world
this message is coming from this
statement here and we have this
statement because we have included io
stream to really make this super clear
we can try to remove this line that says
include io stream
and the moment we do that you're going
to see that this tab says we have
problems
and if you open this tab
you're going to see the message
namespace sdd has no member c out name
space std has no member a and dl
this is because
the z plus plus program doesn't know
what sddc out means because we don't
have the library included and you also
see that we have these squiggly lines to
make it really clear that we have a
problem so to really be able to use this
we have to include a third party library
that brings these features into our
program and that's what the include
statement here is really doing so let's
bring this in
and we're going to say i o stream again
and let's wait and see that the problem
goes away
and the one thing you should really know
is that we don't have a semicolon at the
end of the io stream statement we don't
need to put it there but many c
plus plus statements need a semicolon at
the end
okay i think this really makes it clear
what the include statement here is doing
the other thing we have in our program
is this ant main parenthesis
curly braces thing
this thing here is called the main
function
a function in c plus plus is a block of
code that does a lot of things
but the main function here is special
because it is the starting point of your
c plus plus program
we also call the main function the entry
point of the c plus plus program and
what that means is that if you open the
program the main function is going to be
the very first thing that is going to
run and the things are going to be
executed in the main function in order
so the statement on the top is going to
run first and the statement after that
until we hit the end of the function so
this is what we mean here to really
drive this home we can come here in our
main function and say sdd
number one
and say sdd engl and by the way this e n
d l statement is going to print a new
line
we're going to
see it in effect in a moment let's
actually take it out so that we can see
its effect we're going to also do sddc
out number two
and what this is going to do
is to print number one and number two on
the terminal let's build this program
and if you want to build the default
task you can hit ctrl shift b for it to
happen very fast but i am always going
to come here so that it is really clear
what i am doing a program should be
generated now if we try to run it
by typing
rooster.exe and again we can hit
the app arrow button on our keyboard so
that's the last command that we run from
this terminal runs and this is going to
speed things up a little bit so if we
run this program it should say number
one and number two as you see here
but these two things are cramped on one
line and the reason is we are not
printing new line characters after we
print number one and number two and we
can solve this problem by putting in two
less than symbols and saying std column
column e n d l
this is going to put a new line
character after number one we can build
again
for our new changes to tech effect
after we do that we click on the
terminal hit enter we hit the app arrow
button if we run it's going to say
number one and number two on two
separate lines because we are printing a
new line character after number one i
really hope this makes sense
please do take some time to play with us
because if this is the first time you're
doing this some things might not be
clear and the best way to really make
sense of this is to type code run it and
see the effect of what you type by
running your program so let's do this a
couple of times we're going to do sdd
endl
after
the statement for number two we're going
to do stdc out
number three
and we're going to do stdeandl
to really show the problem again we're
going to take out
stdendl on the number two line
we are going to weld the build is going
to be successful
we're going to click in the terminal hit
enter hit the app arrow button run the
program again and you're going to see
it's saying number one it's going on the
new line printing number two but we not
to jump into the new line from number
two so number two and number three are
going to be cramped on one line that's
what we see here we can solve this again
by putting in a new line after number
two
let's do std
e and d l here
and uh this should solve the problem
again let's build we're going to run our
build task the build is going to be
successful we're going to hit the app
arrow to run the program if we run it
it's going to say number one number two
and number three and this is really good
now it should be clear that statements
in the main function are run in order
from top to bottom and that the program
is going to end when it hits the end of
this curly brace that includes our
function we're going to have a chance to
learn more about functions
in detail later in the course but we are
just getting started and we need to
start somewhere so that's why we're
doing this main function thing here
another thing you can do is return from
the main function and in many examples
you will see people do return 0
something like this
and this is a way for the main function
to send the message to the operating
system if it's finished successfully or
if there was some kind of problem
we're not going to go into any more
details about the main function because
that's really
too much for now we are just getting
started we are trying to get a feel of
how c plus works the main message here
is really that you should be able to
print things to the console using sddc
out you should be able to print a new
line after your message
using sdd ndl this stdc out and
stdendl thank come from the iostream
library that we are including here
if we don't include this library we're
going to have problems because
our surplus plus program is not going to
know where they are coming from so we
should really put this in if we want to
use these features
and we can return from a function to let
the system know the operating system
if the program finished up successfully
or if there was some kind of problem and
again this project is using the
templates we've done before
and this is really all we set out to do
in this lecture trying to make sense of
the main function in c plus plus to
really practice these things i would
challenge you to write a c plus plus
program just like this that is going to
print your name 10 times try to do that
and if you have a problem please do ask
me and i will do the best i can to help
you out
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you found it
interesting we're going to stop here in
this lecture in the next one we're going
to start and learn about comments in c
plus plus go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about comments and c plus plus
comments are the way to put some
messages in your c plus plus chord that
are really meant to be read by humans
and one way we have to do comments in c
plus plus is through this backslash
backslash thing we have here this is
going to comment out the line so the
compiler is really not going to care
about it it's going to think that it is
something that is meant for the
developer to see so this is a one line
comment and this is how you do it in c
plus plus you can also comment out a
block of code in your c plus bus code
and this is something that comes in
quite handy many times you put your
comment in a backslash star and a star
backslash like this this is going to
comment things out in your code and the
compiler is really not going to care
about this let's hop over to visual
studio code and actually play with us so
here we are in the folder that is going
to contain our code the first thing i'm
going to do is go through the template
project i'm going to copy my files
and i'm going to go up again and we're
going to be learning about comments so
i'm going to put this in the folder on
comments i am going to close whatever
folder we have opened in visual studio
code and i'm going to browse to the
location where my project on comment
says
my project is in this folder that is
named three three comments i'm going to
open the folder and if i open the main
cpp file i'm going to find the starter
project we're going to remove this const
eval thank because we're really not
ready to understand this yet it was in
here to help us
test that our compilers support c plus
plus 20. so we're going to remove this
and we're going to put in a message that
says hello world you already know how to
do that from the last lecture so we're
going to say sddc out
hello world and we're going to say
stdendl and don't forget this semicolon
at the end if you do you're going to
have problems so make sure your code
looks like this try to build it to make
sure it's working fine this is going to
run the gcc tasked world we can click on
the terminal here and it's going to
close the terminal
and we can open a new terminal here if
we want if we do dir we're going to find
our rooster program inside we can run it
and it's going to say hello world we
already know to do this from the last
lecture and in this one we are going to
be learning about comments the first
thing you can do is use slash slash so
let's do that
and uh let's put some message here this
branch and the iostream library this is
a nice message that is going to give
some more information about this
statement to whoever might be reading
this program and this is called a one
line comment you can really put this
wherever you want in your c plus plus
file we can go in the main function for
example and say this is going to print
hello world to the console or the
terminal we can really put this anywhere
we can even put it after the return
statement here and really put in
whatever piece of information we think
is going to make sense to wherever it's
going to be reading our program okay
this is how you do a line comment you
can also do comments across different
lines and the way you do that you put
that in the
slash star and go down and say star
slash like this and whatever is going to
be in the middle here is going to be a
comment this is usually called a block
comment you can put in whatever you want
so if you have a piece of text that you
would like to use as a comment in your
program this is one way you can do this
one thing you should know though is that
you cannot nest these things but before
we do that let's try to build our
program to really show that there is no
problem if we have these comments in the
world is successful and if we click on
this terminal and hit enter
and hit clear to clear things out in the
terminal we can try to run our rooster
program and it's going to say hello
world you see that all these green lines
which are comments are really not
affecting the program all the compiler
is going to care about is this include
thing it's going to care about the main
function here it's going to ignore these
green things it's going to be like these
green lines that are our comments are
not in there this is the effect comments
have in your program and we're going to
be using this a lot in this course
one thing you should know though is that
you cannot nest these block comments so
if you try to do something like this
and uh say this is one comment and uh
come again and say this is another
comment you see that we have problems
already nesting is not allowed you're
going to get a compiler error and we're
going to learn more about these errors
in the next lecture but don't do this
don't nest these block comments if you
do that you're going to get some
confusing errors and this is going to be
the cause for them so don't nest your
blog comments it's going to give you
headaches okay this is really all we set
out to do in this lecture learning about
comments in c plus plus you can do one
line comments on a single line like this
you can do block comments to comment out
a block of text you can't nest your blog
comments because that's going to give
you a lot of problems you don't want
that and really use comments wisely and
don't overdo it because it's going to
turn your program into a novel and i
don't think people want that so use this
feature when you need it to give some
more information about your code and
don't overdo this we are going to stop
here in this lecture the next one we're
going to learn about different kinds of
errors and warnings you can see in your
c plus plus program
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about errors and warnings in your
c plus plus programs there are three
kinds of errors or warnings you can get
you can get compile time errors you can
get runtime errors and you can get
warnings but what is really meant by
these things remember the ultimate goal
of every developer or every c plus plus
developer in our case here is to be able
to generate a binary executable file
from the c plus plus code and we have to
run the code through the compiler to be
able to do that and one thing you should
know is that there is a set of
requirements
that the compiler enforces on our code
for it to be able to compile
successfully and those requirements are
the rules really that we have to follow
in our c plus plus program and if we
break those rules we're going to get
problems and these problems are going to
come in the form of compile time errors
run time errors or warnings
let's look at compile time errors in
detail
here we have a simple c plus plus
program that has a few problems we have
forgotten to put the semicolon at the
end of our stdc out statement here and
the compiler is going to freak out
because of this
if we compile this program we're going
to get a bunch of errors and the ide is
going to show us this problem some ides
are going to give you different errors
for example here i was using codelite
and it was saying
error expected semicolon before return
or something like this so this is a
compiler error and if you have this kind
of errors your program is not going to
compile compilation is going to fail
you're going to get this error and
you're not going to get your binary
executable and when you have this you
basically have to go back and fix this
problem compile again and when you get
rid of these problems the compilation is
going to succeed this is what a compile
time error is another thing you can have
is the run time error this is not going
to cause a compile time error the
compilation is going to succeed but when
you run the program it's not going to do
what you intended it to do in the first
place for example you may want it to
print green on some user interface it's
going to print gray or whatever it's
really not going to do what you want so
it's a logical error that you have in
your program and you have to fix it to
get rid of this and another thing you
should know is that sometimes these run
time errors can cause your program to
fail and terminate immediately and we
say that the program has crashed we're
going to see an example of this in a
minute the last kind of problem you can
have in your program is a warning
this is a problem that is not serious
enough for the compiler to halt your
compilation compilation is going to
succeed but this is basically the
compiler telling you you are doing
something that has some problems and you
should really fix it before it becomes a
serious problem so that's going to be a
warning for example here you see some
compilers can warn you when you divide
stuff by zero and we're going to see how
this works the main message in this
lecture is that you may have problems in
your program and they are going to come
in three forms some are going to be
compile time errors some are going to be
run time errors some are going to be
warnings we are going to hop over to
visual studio code and actually play
with this okay here i am in visual
studio code the first thing i'm going to
do is to set up
the template project we're going to be
using in our project here the project is
going to leave in this folder errors and
warnings i am going to copy over the
files and i am going to go in the
current project we're going to be
working on and i am going to open this
folder in visual studio code i am going
to go to file close folder i am going to
close this one and i am going to open
our new project i am going to browse to
it the project is this one i am going to
select it and select folder and it is
going to open up in visual studio code i
am going to close this welcome screen
and open our main cpp file we are going
to get rid of this constable fan this is
a c plus plus 20 test
thing we had and we don't really need it
now we're going to get there in due time
what we want to see is compile time
errors we're going to put in our stdc
out statement hello world
as we usually do
we're going to end this stdndm and we're
going to
remove the semicolon on purpose and if
we try to compile our program like this
we're going to get a compile time error
this is what we want to see so let's try
and build our program we're going to run
the task to build with gcc and you see
that the world fails we're going to get
a bunch of errors in our terminal it's
going to say in function it main
expected a semicolon before return it's
going to try its best to tell you what
the problem is but sometimes these
errors can be really confusing in this
case it is really easy because we
introduced this error on purpose so
we're going to fix it in a minute but
before we do that i want you to see
these problems tab it is where the
problems are going to show up in visual
studio code so you should see your
problems in here or through the terminal
here okay one thing you should know is
that when you have a compiler arrow
compilation is not going to succeed and
you're not going to have your binary
file which is what you really want so to
fix this problem we're going to put in
our semicolon here we're going to build
again we're going to go to terminal run
task we're going to build with gcc and
this time you're going to see that
compilation is going to succeed and we
have our program here we can run it
through the terminal here so we're going
to click the terminal is going to go
away but we can open our own
and if we do dur we're going to see our
files in here and we can run our program
we can say rooster and if we run we're
going to have hello world so i hope this
really makes it very clear what a
compile time error as so this is one
kind of error you can get the other one
is around time error and this comes in
the form of things that don't work as
you really expected so let's say we are
trying to do some computation in our
program
we
try to take 7 and divide this by 0 for
example and this is a statement there is
a load in c plus plus so let's try and
build this and see what we get because
this is a common scenario where we have
run time errors we're going to run the
task to build with gcc okay if we do
this you see that world finished with
warnings we didn't get a compile time
arrow and our build was successful so to
really prove this i'm going to
go back in our directory i'm going to do
dur you're going to see that rooster is
there i'm going to remove it i'm going
to say
rooster.exe this is how we remove stuff
from the command line when i do this and
do dirt again the
executable file should be gone so let's
try and build with this statement and
and you're going to see that we get a
warning and not a compile time error
like we had here so we're going to go to
terminal run task we're going to build
with gcc and you're going to see that
we're going to have our executable here
but we had a warning and it's saying
that division by 0 was detected in our
program and it is a recipe for disaster
so why is it a disaster let's try and
run this program so we're going to
dirt to prove it's here and we're going
to run it if we run it it's going to say
hello world and it's going to end let's
try and actually use our own terminal to
see if we have a better chance of seeing
the problem here so i'm going to reveal
in explorer by clicking on main cpp and
i am going to try and open a terminal
window here powershell that we open
ourselves we've done this before
this shouldn't be new to you by now
so we're going to do dirt in here
and we're going to try and run the
program and it's going to run so so it's
not really giving us a run time error
here because we're not capturing this or
trying to use the result of this
division here we're just doing the
division which is a problem so let's try
and capture this we haven't learned
about variables yet but what we're going
to do now is do end value and we're
going to assign the result of this
division to this value and let's try
printing the result of dividing a number
by zero so we're going to do stdc out
and we're going to say value and this is
how you can print a value out on the
console okay now that we have this and
let's try and weld we're going to run
tasks and worldwide gcc we're going to
get the same warning but if we try to
run the program we're not going to get
what we expect let's run rooster exe we
expect it to say hello world and printed
the value but you see that it's really
struggling to print the value and it
gave up and ended immediately so this is
one example of a runtime error that you
can face in your program there are many
other kinds that we're going to see as
we progress in the course
here we are just trying to raise your
awareness on these problems so that you
can know how to fix them when they come
up okay so this is all i can share with
you now about runtime errors we also had
a chance to see that this is also going
to give you a warning and a visual
studio code here is also helping out
telling us that we may have a problem
it's turning the main cpp file yellow
and it's saying that there is one
problem in this file and if you go here
you're going to see that we have a
warning here okay so this is one way you
have to see this so this is not
recommended to do so we're going to
comment this out okay this is really all
i had to share in this lecture we had a
chance to look at compile time errors we
also had a chance to look at warnings
and run time errors using this example
if you get a warning it is a message the
compiler is giving you that you should
really look it up and fix the problem
before it becomes more serious compile
time errors are going to cause your
compilation to fail and that's a really
good thing because the compiler is going
to stop you from generating a binary
that doesn't really do what you expect
it to do so that's a good thing but
sometimes the compiler want to give you
a compile arrow and you have a chance to
run into a runtime error and that's
really bad so be careful about these
things and when you have problems visual
studio code is going to show you the
problem in terminal or in this problems
tab and you're going to be able to fix
it up we're going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
learn a little more about statements and
functions go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to learn about a little more about
statements and functions in c plus plus
a statement is a basic unit of
computation in c plus plus you can say
that it is the smallest thing your cpu
can execute in your program every c plus
plus program is a collection of
statements so you're going to have a
bunch of statements that are organized
in a certain way to achieve whatever it
is you want and statements in c plus
plus must end with the semicolon we saw
in the last lecture that not putting
that semicolon is going to result in a
compile time error here is a basic
sample c plus plus program that we're
going to use to learn about statements
in the main function here we have two
variables declared we haven't really
learned about variables but they are a
way to store data in your program and
here we are storing two decimal numbers
one is called first number the second is
called second number we can do something
with these variables that we have in our
program for example we can add them to
have another variable in our program and
we can print that so you see here we are
saying stdc out the sum of two numbers
is sum so this is going to print 21
because it's going to add 12 and 9 and
the result of that is going to be
displayed on the terminal if we run this
program what i really want you to notice
is that this and first the number equals
12 thing is a statement in c plus plus
so it must end with a semicolon the line
here with second number is also a
statement so it must end with a
semicolon every single line we have here
in the main function is really a
statement and it must end with a
semicolon if we don't put the semicolon
in place we're going to get a compiler
error okay one other thing that is
really important to keep in mind is that
statements are executed in order in your
program and the order is from top to
bottom if you go back to our program
here so the first statement is the one
with first number here 12 is going to be
installed in memory when this statement
is executed by your computer and we're
going to go to the second statement with
second number and we're going to keep
going until we hit the end of the main
function and the return statement is
going to execute and when the main
function returns or terminates we're
going to get the return value sent to
your operating system and it's going to
know if your program ended successfully
or with a problem and the operating
system is going to know what to do with
that information execution keeps going
until we hit the end of the program or
if there is any other condition causing
for the program to terminate and we're
going to have more details about these
things later i just want you to know
that the statements are executed in
order in your main function another
concept i really want you to have an
idea about is the concept of functions a
function is really like a machine you
give it input and it's going to give you
output if we look at the operation here
to add first a number to second number
we can consider first number and second
number as input to the function and sum
is the output of the function we can
visualize that like this so we have a
first number and the second number we
pass that into our machine which is
really a function and we're going to get
the result of this function in a return
value or something that we get out of
the function as our result c plus plus
has a special syntax we use to define
functions this is our function to add
numbers on the left we have an integer
which is code name for a whole number in
c plus plus it's a number without
decimal points and it's a whole number
after that we have the name of the
function and we can name it whatever we
want and after that we're going to have
the list of parameters that we can pass
to the function and this is going to
work as the input to the function
after you do that you're going to have a
pair of curly braces the one is here the
other is here to the end and within
those curly braces it's going to be the
body of the function inside the function
you see that we are declaring a variable
which is called sum
and we are storing the sum of first
number and second number in this
variable
and we are making this function return
the sum as the result and we're going to
be able to capture it if we call this
function in a function like me you're
going to see how this works in a minute
a function must be defined before it's
used so you can't really call a function
you haven't defined first in your c plus
plus program and here is a slightly
complete program to really put all these
ideas together we have our function to
add numbers it takes two numbers first
number and second number it's going to
add them up and store the results and
we're going to return some to be used by
whoever called this function and if you
look in our main program we have a
statement here we're going to store the
result of add numbers in the sum
variable and we pass first number and
second number in the function and we're
going to have that result stored in here
here we also call the function with
direct numbers you see that we pass in
34 and the seven and we're going to
print out the result here this is the
basic idea i want you to have about
functions they are reusable pieces of
code that group together a bunch of
statements to do whatever it is we
wanted to do in that function one
benefit about functions is that we can
reuse the code here if you look here we
are calling this function multiple times
without really rewriting these
statements that are inside the function
i know some of these concepts might be
cryptic to you right now we are going to
go to visual studio code and try this in
code and you're going to see exactly how
this works okay here we are in our
folder where we are storing our projects
i am going to grab the code from the
template project i am going to put that
in the current project which is
statements and functions i'm going to
paste that in here and i am going to
open this up in visual studio code i am
going to close the project we have right
now and i am going to open our new
project let's browse to its location i
am going to open the project on
statements and functions let's open this
folder in visual studio code and we're
going to have our starter project here i
am going to take out whatever we have in
the main function and take out this
contival thing we don't really need it
and we are going to try and define two
variables using two statements we are
going to say and first number and we're
going to put in a value let's say three
and we have to remember to end this with
a semicolon so this makes our statement
we can encode this in a comment to make
this pretty clear we're going to also
define a second variable so we're going
to say ent to
mean that it is a whole number it
doesn't have decimal points like 2.5 it
is a whole number like one or seven or
ten so we're going to say second number
we can give it a name and uh let's put
in a seven we're going to store these
values in our program and we can print
these values out let's print them out
first so we're going to say stdc out we
already know how to do that and we can
say first number and we can change these
output statements and say the first
number is first number you can do that
std endl and you can notice that visual
studio code is really helping out in
auto completing things we have in our
program let's print the second number to
really practice this so if we do std
you're going to see that it's going to
give us a bunch of options we can choose
from if you want you can scroll through
this with your mouse or you can just
type whatever you want to type so i am
going to do c out and it's going to try
and help out if i really want i can come
on c out here and click on it and it's
going to be auto completed which is
pretty cool so we're going to say second
number and we're going to say second
number here and it's going to auto
complete for us
endl and we can try and compile this
program before we do i want you to guess
what we're going to get when we run this
program give it a guess we are then
going to go to terminal run task and
we're going to build this with gcc the
world is going to be successful we're
going to open this in our terminal the
terminal goes away no problem we're
going to open it again and we are going
to go in our folder and do the ir and
you're going to see that we have
rooster.exe our program we can run it
and it's going to say first number three
and second number s7 this is what we
have stored in these variables and the
benefit of storing your data in
variables is that you can change the
variables and let the rest of your
program really do the same things and
pick up the data that you have in those
variables for example we can put 13 in
the first number
and if we build again this number is
going to be picked up by this code and
we didn't need to go in and manually
change data in these sddc out statements
here let's weld so that we can see this
and we can close this by clicking and if
we run rooster again it's going to say
13 and 7. play with this a couple of
times until you really feel confident
and if you have any problem don't
hesitate to ask me i am going to do the
best i can to help you out
now that we have these numbers stored in
our program we can add them up let's say
and some we're going to declare another
variable and we're going to say it's
equal to first number plus second number
and we're going to end this with a
semicolon and we're going to print the
sum out
let's do sddc out and we're going to say
the sum is sum we're going to print our
variable here and we're going to print a
new line character with std endl we're
going to build our program so that our
changes are reflected in our binary here
so we're going to go to terminal
run task weld with gcc the build is
going to be successful we're going to
press any key we are going to click here
in the terminal and we're going to hit
enter and run rooster again and we
should see the sum and you see it says
the sum is 20 which is what we expect
now we are doing the sum here but it
would really be better if we're not
doing the sum in the main function here
what if we actually took this code and
wrapped it in a function that we could
reuse whatever we want we have seen how
we can declare a function so let's do
that we're going to follow the same
structure we saw in the slides earlier
so we're going to say and this is going
to be the return value or what we get
out of the function then we're going to
put in the name of the function we're
going to say add numbers and we're going
to pass in the parameters the parameters
can really have any name you want but
you have to specify
the type of the parameter first so the
parameters are also going to be whole
numbers like 1 5 7 or whatever you want
and we're going to say first program
and the second is going to also be a
whole number an integer and it's going
to be second
param okay after we do this we're going
to specify the body of the function
which is going to be between these curly
braces i am going to jump to the next
line so that this is really easy to see
so i am going to define our sum variable
inside the function it's going to be a
whole number and i can call it whatever
i want so let's call it result because
it's going to be the result of this
function and the result is going to be
the sum of first param and second param
okay i hope this makes sense and we're
going to end this with a semicolon
because every statement in c plus plus
has to end with the semicolon after we
have the result
we need to give it back to whoever
called this function and we're going to
do that with a return statement and
we're going to return the result to
whoever
might have called this function here now
that we have the function we can
actually use it we're going to go back
in our main function and what we're
going to do
is to reuse this sum variable and store
in whatever is returned from our
function the syntax for that is going to
be sum
and we're going to say equals and we're
going to say add numbers and we can pass
in whatever two numbers that we want to
add up let's pass in 25
and 7 for example
we would expect this to give us 32
so if we print the sum again we can just
complete this statement
that prints the sum and reuse it here
let's align this a little bit and i want
you to take a guess at what we are going
to get from this program right now we
have these two numbers we are adding
them up if we get here this should print
the first number which is going to be a
13 so here we expect to get 13 and by
the time we hit this second number
statement we are going to print the
second number it's going to be 7. if we
get here we're going to print whatever
is stored in sum and in sum we have the
sum of first number and second number so
this should print 20 right and here we
are doing another sum of two numbers but
we are using a predefined function
that we have here before the main
function because you have to define the
function before you use it okay if we
add 25 and seven we are going to fall
into this function and it's going to add
those numbers up and we're going to get
a 32 in here
and that's what we're going to return
and it is going to be saved in this
variable if we print it out it's going
to give us 32. i hope this makes sense
let's build and run our program run task
world with gcc the world is going to go
fine we're going to go back to our
terminal here that's clear so that
things don't disturb us and uh bring in
some confusion we're going to run our
rooster program and exactly what we have
here we have a 13 from the first
statement here we have a 7 from this
statement here we have a 20 from this
sum here which is here and we have a 32
that we got from this function the good
thing about functions is that we can
reuse them now that we know how to use
it we can use it again and we can say
sum equals
add numbers and we can say 30 and
54 for example you add them up and
you're going to get the results so we're
going to print the result some and we're
going to put in the sum i really want
you to take some time and play with this
statement so that these things make
sense it's really not that difficult but
you just have to rock your brains around
how c plus plus defines these things so
we have this statement and we are adding
30 and 54 so it should get an 84 after
the 32 here let's weld we're going to
run the task to world with gcc we're
going to click on the terminal here and
hit enter let's clear so that we don't
have things disturbing us and we're
going to run our program and we have our
trusty 84 here i really hope this makes
sense and as a bonus i'm going to show
you that you can also call things
in the stdc out statement here without
having to store them in some predefined
variables and sometimes this comes in
handy so you can say std see out and
we're going to say sum and you might say
add numbers right in here and you're
going to say 3 for example and uh 42 and
this is going to give us a 45 that's
what we should expect to see after 84
here
so that's world and running the task to
build with gcc the world is going to be
successful we click on the terminal here
we hit enter so that we see our terminal
with output we're going to clear so that
we see our output without noise we're
going to run our program and we're going
to see a 45 here i really hope this
makes sense the whole point of this
lecture was to make you aware of
statements and function a statement is
the most basic unit in your c plus plus
program it basically lives on one line
but it can also spread across different
lines but we're not going to look at
that here maybe we're going to see that
later in the course statements are
executed in order so when our main
function gets to be run by the computer
it's going to go from the first
statement second statement third
statement and it's going to go until it
hits the end and we can see that here in
the order in which our numbers are
printed it is going from top to bottom
we have also seen that we can split our
code in different functions and wrap
whatever functionality we have in a
function we have seen the basic concepts
on functions a function has a return
value it has a name and you have to give
it the parameters and you put the body
of your function within these two curly
braces as an exercise i would challenge
you to do a function that multiplies two
numbers and call it in the main function
here to see the result if you have any
problem please do ask me i am going to
do the best i can to help you out this
covers all we set out to do in this
lecture and i hope you found it
interesting we're going to stop here in
this lecture in the next one we're going
to see how we can input and output
things from our c plus plus program go
ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about how we can get thanks in our
program and get things out of our
program and that's basically input and
output to and from our program we have
actually been doing this all along we
have been printing things from our
program to the console
and with this technique you can really
think of stdc out
as a highway that goes from your program
to the terminal you can basically think
of it like this data is going from your
program to sddc out and it's going from
here to the terminal and from this you
might get an idea why these
less than signs kind of point to the
left because data is going from your
program to htdc out and these two
symbols point to the left they point to
hddc out to signal to the fact that data
is going from here to here i really hope
this makes sense because sometimes these
things can confuse people this is the
reason why it's going from your data to
stdc out data is basically going from
your program into httc out and the sddc
out is one way we have to get data from
our program to the console there are
many others we have std c e r r or std
server this is what i'd like to call it
and what it does it prints errors to the
console we have stdc log which is going
to print log messages why do we have
these different things different
programs might decide to format these
messages differently because they are
different messages one is a simple
message from the program another is the
narrows you might want to turn this red
to really bring the attention
to this message because the user has to
solve that problem another might be a
log message that you want to store in
some file or some database
uses for these things differ and c plus
plus makes sure to give you different
ways to state your intent through the
tools that you use we have looked at
sddc out sddc error and stdc log what
does sd c i n do it does the reverse
it's going to take data out of the
program and bring that into the program
so let's look at a few examples using
these here we have an example of
printing data from the program to the
terminal through c out
cr and c log
here we have a hello world message going
to c out
here we have a number going to c out
this is what we've been doing all along
we can also do a variable storing the
edge for example it's a whole number
it's an integer
so we print this out and the message is
going to go from the program to cl so
you can think that things are going from
the program to sddc out i really wanted
this to make sense okay if we go down
we're going to see that we can use cr to
print errors to the terminal and we
might say something went wrong or
something along these lines to bring the
attention to the problem and we can use
c log to print log messages and they
work the same way they all use the
stream output operator and it is going
to take data from the program to
the output stream really this is what we
mean here here is an example of how you
might read data and bring that into the
program here we have two variables one
is the age it's a whole number or an
integer and z plus plus and the other is
a string this is a type that allows you
to store strings in c plus plus we're
going to learn a little more about this
later but here i want to use it to
really make it clear that you can get
things from the outside and bring that
data in your program so we're going to
let the user type in the last name and
this statement here with cin
is getting data from the stream or from
the highway through which data comes
into our program and bringing that in
our program and here it should be clear
that the flow of data is in this
direction data is going from c i n and
we're storing that in a variable that we
have in our program that is called name
we do the same thing and ask the user to
print the age and they are going to
print that and the data is going to come
from cin and we're going to store that
in our edge variable here after we
collect the data from the user we're
going to print that and we're going to
say hello we're going to print the name
and we're going to say they are whatever
years old this is what this program does
and i really hope it makes it clear
how data input works through streams in
surplus plus another thing we can do
with
sddcin is chaining input and we can use
this technique to grab data in one
statement look at the program down here
to really understand this we have the
same variables age and name we let the
user type in the last name and age
separated by spaces
and we grab the data like this we first
grab the name after that we grab the age
and we're going to print the same things
and we can chain
input stream operators like this to grab
the data in one go and this may come in
handy sometimes
before we try these things in visual
studio code i want to bring your
attention to a problem that you are
likely to come in contact with and that
is reading data with spaces what if the
user types the name
with spaces for example you asked me to
type my name i'm not going to type
daniel i'm going to type daniel cafwaya
and your program is going to run into
problems c plus plus allows to solve
this problem using std get line and you
use it
using this syntax you're going to pass
in the stream where the data is going to
go and you're going to pass in the
variable that is going to read the data
and you're going to have this
information stored correctly in your
program this might be not making sense
yet to you we're going to go to visual
studio code and play with us and i am
sure it is going to make sense okay here
we are in visual studio code and we have
our project where we're going to store
our files data imported output we're
going to copy code from our template
project and we're going to put the data
in and i am going to open this folder in
visual studio code so let's close
whatever we have now and i am going to
open my folder let's browse there i am
on this folder data input and output i
am going to select that and the project
is going to open up in visual studio
code i am going to jump to my main
function i am going to take out things
we don't need and the first thing we're
going to do is printing data we have
really done this so we're going to
practice this a little bit we can say
stdc out
and we can say hello c plus plus 20 why
not and we're going to put an std
endl at the end and remember our
semicolon and here i want you to really
put in your head that data is going from
our program here to hddc out and sddc
out is going to dump that on the
terminal that's how this works you can
also do a variable let's say ant
age for example let's say 21 and end
this with the semicolon and we can also
print the h we can say sddc out
and we can say
age this is going to be sent to the
output stream
and we're going to do sdd and dl to add
a
new line character at the end and we can
try and build this before the program
gets more complicated let's go to
terminal we're going to run the test
world with gcc
and if we hit enter on the terminal here
the terminal is going to go away we're
going to create a new one no big deal
and uh if we do dir we're going to find
our rooster program if we run it it's
going to say hello c plus 20 and the age
is going to be 21. we are successfully
taking data from our program and
printing that to the terminal this is
pretty cool and you can think of sddc
out as the highway that is really going
to take your data from your program and
bring that to sddc out like this
we're also going to take the age it's
going to go through sddc out and it's
going to show up here you can think of
this like this okay now that we have
used sddc out we can use sddcr and sddc
log in the same way so we're going to
say sddcr
i'm going to say error message and the
message is going to be something is
wrong you may do whatever you want in
here and we have to remember to put a
new line character otherwise data is
going to be cramped on one line we can
also use sddc log it really works the
same way c log and we can say log
message and we're going to say something
happened
and we remember to put std endl and our
semicolon if we build this program you
might guess what it's going to do it's
going to print these things on the
terminal
but this might be
useful
to terminal programs that support
features to format different messages
directly the program is going to know
that one message is a simple message the
other is an arrow the other is a log
message let's run our program
but before we do that let's clear so
that we don't have noise here we're
going to run the program and it's going
to say the error message and the log
message here okay now what we're going
to look at is how we can get data into
our program and data is going to be
going in a different direction
it's going to be coming from the
terminal and flowing into our program
what we're going to do we're going to do
ant age one this is a new variable so
we're going to put in data and we're
going to bring in a string library to
allow our program to store strengths the
way we're going to do that we're going
to include
strength this is how you do it in c plus
plus we haven't really learned about
this type it's a powerful type in c plus
plus but we will get it there when we
have more powerful tools to really
understand it we are just getting
started here so what we're going to do
we're going to say std strength and
we're going to say name
and we're going to ask the user to print
their name and age you already know how
to do that so we're going to say please
type your name and age and we're going
to do stdndl on this and how we're going
to get data in the program we're going
to use
stdcin and we're going to do std
cim and data is going to be going from
the stream to the program so the
stream input operator here points to the
right
and the data is going to be going in the
name variable because that's what
they're going to be typing in first
because that's what we told them to do
so we're going to store the name
and we're going to say
stdcim data is going to be flowing from
sddcin into our h1 variable okay now
that the user has given us their
information we can greet them with a
personalized message we're going to say
stdc out hello and we're going to put
out their name and we're going to tell
them you are and we're going to put the
age
one because that's what they're going to
give us here and i'm going to say
years
and we're going to put an std endl here
i'm going to grab this and pull this to
the left so that we can see our entire
program here that's helpful so what we
are doing here we are getting data from
the user and we are storing that in our
variables and we are printing the
message so that the user can see it i
don't want the first things we did here
to disturb us when we world and try this
out so i am going to comment this out
and comment the first block of code out
using blog comments i think this is the
first time we use this and uh this is
going to be ignored by the compiler now
and it is only going to consider this
and this is going to be pretty cool
let's go down a little bit here and i
try to build the program we're going to
run the task that welds with gcc and uh
looks like the world is good we're going
to hit enter and we're going to clear so
that we are not disturbed by this we're
going to run the program let's say
rooster.exe
it's going to ask me to type my name and
age my name is daniel i'm going to type
that hit enter it's going to want me to
type my age
so i am going to say
33 for example
and it's going to tell me hello daniel
you are 33 years old i put a slash here
we can try and run it again so that i
don't have to make that mistake again so
daniel that's my name i hit enter i say
and if i run
it's going to say hello daniel you are
33 years old i really hope this brings
the point home
that
stdcin is a highway
that takes data from the terminal into
your program so this is really what is
happening here when i type daniel it's
going to flow from the terminal and it's
going to go into my variable which is
name here and when i type the age it's
going to go in my edge variable here and
all these happening through
in here okay one other thing we can do
is
grab the data and put that in our
variables in one go so what we can do
here is comment this out and we're going
to do
stdcin and we're going to put that in
name and we're going to change these two
things and put the other piece of data
in h1 if you run the program it's going
to work exactly the same way but we are
grabbing the data in one line so let's
weld to see this in action we're going
to run the task that worlds with gcc
we're going to click here and we're
going to clear if we run rooster it's
going to ask for the name and the age
i'm going to put in daniel and i'm going
to put my h and say 33 for example and
it's going to do exactly the same thing
but we have one compact line the last
thing i want to show you in this lecture
is how you can grab data with spaces
because if i try to put in data with
spaces here the program is going to fail
miserably let me show you this i'm going
to clear and i'm going to run rooster
again and i'm going to say daniel i'm
going to put in my full name and uh it's
really not grabbing the second name and
it didn't give me a chance to input my
age and this is really bad
so c plus plus provides a way to solve
this using std get line so let's see
what we are doing here and before we
play with this we're going to comment
out what we had here so that
it doesn't disturb us in what we are
about to do so let's come down here and
say that we were doing data input this
is helpful here and we're going to go
down and grab data with spaces so i am
going to set up another strength and
this is going to store my full name
that's what i'm going to say here and to
grab it i'm going to tell the user to
type in their full name and age so i am
going to sddc out so the way i'm going
to grab the data i'm going to do std get
line you see that we have this function
here and it's going to take an input
stream so asd dcin is going to work and
the second parameter is going to be the
variable where this string data is going
to be stored we're going to pass in our
full name and this is going to work just
fine and we're going to also grab the h
using the same technique we've used
before so we're going to say
stdcin and we're going to store that in
our h3 variable once we have the data we
can greet our user using the same
message we had before so i'm going to
copy that if i can do that and i'm going
to paste that here i'm going to bring
this to the same location it's going to
be full name here and it's going to say
h3 and let's try and weld we're going to
terminal run the task to bolt with gcc
and we have a problem because we forgot
our semicolon see how these problems
might come to you uh-huh so we're going
to put in our semicolon and another
thing i really want you to see
is that you can
bring these things to the next line if
they turn out too long like we see here
so i can for example put this to the
next line and it is going to work just
fine so what i am going to do i'm going
to try and weld again run task to build
with gcc you see that the world is good
we're going to
bring in our terminal i'm going to clear
so that we don't have noise here and
we're going to run our program it's
going to ask me to put in my full name
i'm going to say daniel
and it's going to want the age i'm going
to say 33 and it's going to reach me
hello daniel gaway you are 33 years old
we are able to bring data with spaces
into our program and this concludes what
we had to say in this lecture i hope it
made it very clear what these htd n and
stdc out things are they are basically
highways that take data out of your
program or bring data into your program
and the way you use them is what we've
done here in this course i would
encourage you to play with us a couple
of times if this is the first time
you're doing this we are going to stop
here in this lecture in the next one
we're going to try and recap on the c
plus plus development workflow go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to explore
the c plus plus execution model and show
you a simplified version of the memory
model of your c plus plus program here
is how our program looks it is a simple
program in our main function it is going
to call a simple function that is going
to add two numbers we have seen a
program like this before and when we
compile it it's going to be turned into
a binary this black icon here represents
the binary executable and it is not in
the format
that you can read with your eyes if we
come back here to what we were doing in
the last lecture we can see our rooster
executable binary here if you try to
open it here you're going to see that
visual studio code is going to say the
file is not displayed in the editor
because it is either binary or uses an
unsupported text encoding so it says i
can't really say this because it's
binary and it says do you want to open
it anyway if i try to open it it's going
to be just some gibberish because this
is binary it is meant to be
read by programs it is not meant to be
by ides or text editors like visual
studio code so this is the binary file
we have here i tried to put a simplified
version of this program to represent
binary so that we can follow it up but
it is not in the form that is readable
by any human out there unless you are a
machine so why is it in binary because
binary format is easily understandable
by your cpu and we're going to see how
your program is loaded in memory and
executed statement by statement by the
cpu so that you can really understand
this so here is a representation of your
program here we have our how to drive
and we have the program sitting
somewhere on our hard drive in binary
format and it's waiting to be run by you
by double clicking on it or opening it
in the terminal and on the left here we
see a representation of the memory of
our computer and when i say memory i
mean random access memory i don't mean
memory on your hard drive this should be
really clear this is the random access
memory of your computer that is running
your programs very fast so when you
double click on our program or if we
open it in the terminal the binary file
is going to be loaded up in memory and
you see it in red here this is a
representation of that and it is ready
to be run by the cpu by the time the cpu
says in the memory location it's going
to know i have a program to run and the
cpu is going to start running it
statement by statement it is going to
start by the top so it's going to see
that it needs to allocate space to store
our integer a it's going to allocate to
that somewhere on the memory in yellow
here you see a and it's going to see
that it should store in a value of 10
and it's going to do that you can see
that here it's going to go to the next
statement and the next statement tells
it to allocate space for
a value b and it's going to store in f5
it's going to go to the next statement
it's a variable called c it's going to
allocate space for it but we didn't
specify a value for c so what it's going
to do is store in some junk value the
value in there is really unspecified at
the moment it's going to jump to the
next statement and what it's going to do
is print some things on the console and
it is going to do that it's going to
jump to the next statement and it is
going to print statement 2 and here it
is going to notice that it is going to
call a function i don't know if you have
noticed but the cpu has allocated a
special memory location for our function
the function doesn't leave with our code
here or anywhere near the variables that
we have here there might be a huge chunk
of memory between these two or three
things so the cpu knows that it is going
to jump to another location it's going
to ask itself if i jump to that location
to run this function how am i going to
come back and the cpu is smart enough to
store the return address and that's what
it's going to do it's going to say if i
go to that function i want to come back
to the address 6 and run whatever is
after this address so it's going to
store 6 and cpu memory and it's going to
jump to the function it's going to take
the first parameter as a and the second
parameter as b so a is done the
parameter 1 is going to be 10 it's going
to take parameter 2 it's going to be 5
because it is b here and in b we have a
5 and it is going to jump to the next
statement in the function and it is
going to add up parameter 1 and
parameter 2. after it adds those things
up it's going to return the result to c
we can see that here okay that's what
the cpu is going to do it's going to put
the results in c and the result is a 15
so we're going to write that in there
and now that the function is really done
it's going to come back to its address
and it is going to jump to the next
segment after that it is going to
print three statement three it is going
to jump through the next line and print
statement four it's going to do that and
by this time we have reached the end of
our program and it is going to be popped
off the memory and your program is
basically going to end this is how your
program is executed by your cpu and why
am i showing you this because it is
really good to have an idea of how
memory is allocated and used by your
program another good reason is that some
c plus plus feature require you to have
an understanding of a memory model like
this to understand how they work for
example you have seen that to call this
function the program had to jump from
address 6 to 30 and this is really heavy
especially if you are running a simple
function like we are doing here to add
two numbers so the cpu can realize that
and optimize this call to the function
to an inline function and add these two
numbers up right here at address six
without jumping to this address here and
this may come in handy and you need an
understanding of this memory model to
really understand these features this is
just one example i am giving you you are
going to reuse this model a lot in your
career as a class plus developer and i
thought it was a really good idea for
you to understand it firsthand this is
really all i had to share in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
in the next one we're going to try and
understand the difference between three
key components of the c plus plus
programming language go ahead and finish
up here and meet me there in this
lecture i want to highlight the
differences between what we call a c
plus plus core language feature or a
standard library feature or an stl
feature because these are terms that
come up a lot if you happen to read some
documentation about c plus plus a core
feature is really a basic building block
that makes up the c plus plus
programming language you can think of it
for example how you define variables the
rules that govern how you can define and
use a function in c plus plus the rules
that say what you can do and not do with
the basic features of c plus plus that's
really what can be qualified as the core
feature of the c plus plus programming
language i don't know if that makes any
sense if we come back in visual studio
code we have a program we have used in
the last few lectures for example these
basic types that you use in c plus plus
the rules that define how you can define
a function for example if you put a
an angle bracket here and try to compile
this program it is not going to work
because we have violated the rules of
the c plus plus programs the basic rules
that define how the c plus plus
programming language works the basic
types that are defined in the c plus
plus programming language these little
things make up the raw ingredients you
use to make up a proper c plus plus
programs and these little row components
that you use to put together a c plus
plus program are called core features
you can
think of them as the foundation on top
of which we really build daily use c
plus plus programs the standard library
is a set of ready to use
highly specialized components that we
can easily use in our c plus plus
programs and again coming back to our
program in visual studio code iostream
here is a standard library feature
string here is a standard library thing
we have in the c plus plus programming
language and again the c plus plus
standard library tries to provide highly
specialized components that we can use
in regular c plus plus programs when you
use the c plus plus programming language
you don't really want to extend the c
plus plus programming language you want
to use it to build something of your own
and uh the standard library features are
things you use to work on your programs
very fast for example we have used sddc
out without really going into the
details of how the data is taken from
this program to the terminal that's
really advanced and probably complicated
but it is wrapped into this reusable
components and one of them is iostream
and we can use it relatively easily in
our c plus plus program okay i hope now
you have a better idea of what the c
plus plus standard library is now what
is the stl the stl is really part of the
c plus plus standard library but it is a
collection of container types think of
them as collections of things and we
have a set of types that allow us to
store collections we have algorithms or
functions that work on these collections
and we have specialized types that are
called iterators that allow us to
navigate through these containers
potentially running these algorithms on
each element in the collection this is
probably not making sense by now but you
can think of the stl as a highly
specialized part of the c plus plus
standard library and we're going to
learn about many features of these
things throughout the course but i want
you to have a basic understanding
between these three terms a core feature
of the c plus plus programming language
is standard library feature and the stl
and i really hope this is clear to you
by now in this chapter we're going to
learn about variables and data types
before we talk about variables and data
types i would like to take a moment and
recap on what we know by now
and if you look at these cards many of
these things should make sense now you
know about the main function you know
that it is the entry point of your
program you know that your program is
going to be made up of statements and
statements and with a semicolon in c
plus plus
you know about functions errors warnings
you now have an idea about how you can
handle input and output from your
program you can use comments you know
about the memory model and the execution
model that we talked about in the last
lecture you know quite a lot now we have
been using a program like this to do
things in the last chapter but there is
one thing that isn't really explained
yet and that is this ant this end is a
type that is predefined in c plus plus
and c plus plus predefines many types
here we have a couple of these types for
you to see as examples it is one of them
we have seen it a lot of times in the
last chapter it is used to represent
whole numbers like one two and three but
we have others for example double and
float are used to represent fractional
numbers numbers that have decimal points
for example 2.5 7.3 and numbers like
that and we're going to see the
difference between these two another one
that is commonly used is char or car and
it is used to represent characters in
memory and you can store in characters
like a b c and d and all the other
characters you can really put in we have
a bull which is a type that is going to
store two possible states the only
values you can really store in here are
true or false and we're going to see how
this works void is uh somewhat confusing
because it represents a typeless type
and it is really meaningful when we get
to talk about functions in detail so
we're going to learn more about the void
type a little later in the course we
also have the auto type which is really
not a type it is a keyword you use in c
plus plus to deduce other types and
we're going to see how this works later
in the course these are a few examples
of types we can use in c plus plus and
we are going to play with most of them
in this chapter another thing i really
want you to see is what does it mean to
really put a 4 in a variable in your
program everything you have in this
program here is represented by ones and
zeros in the computer's memory it really
looks like this it's a bunch of ones and
zeros in the ram of your computer and
there must be a technique to make sense
of this gibberish here and store data
that makes sense to humans and the
starting point is to group these ones
and zeros into little chunks that we can
manipulate each of these ones and zeros
is called a bet so this zero here is a
bit this one here is a bet and if we
group eight beats together they are
going to form what we call a byte okay
if it makes sense you can group your
bits in bytes or if it makes sense to
group them in groups of 16 you can do
that like we see here we're going to see
a little more details about this in the
next lecture okay here you see that if
you really want you can treat each bit
as a self-contained piece of data but
this is really not very useful but there
are some corner use cases for this okay
now we really have two sides on the
right we have data in the format that is
really convenient and understandable by
humans and on the left we have how data
is represented in memory so there must
be a way to transform between these two
forms of data because humans can't
really handle these ones and zeros well
and we do the transformation between
these two representations of data using
number systems we have a few number
systems available to us that we can use
binary octal hexadecimal are a few
examples and we're going to learn about
them starting in the next lecture so go
ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn a little more about number systems
number systems allow us to transform
data from the form that is really
convenient for humans in a form that is
convenient for computers in these ones
and zeros that you see on the left we
can also use them to do the reverse go
from ones and zeros and go in the format
that is convenient to humans like this
22 or this steve name here to make sense
of how these number systems work let's
analyze the decimal system that we
really use in daily life and that is
usually called base 10. so if you look
at this
2371 number here we can really split it
in the form that you see to the right
here if you try and take this expression
we have on the right here and evaluate
it you're going to get this number here
2 times 10 to the power of 3 this
evaluates to 2000 and this one here is
going to evaluate to 300 this one is
going to evaluate to 70 and the last one
is going to evaluate to one and if you
add these things up you're going to end
up with this number so this is how we
can take a number and uh make up a base
10 representation of it we can do the
same thing for 924 here or 47 here it
really is basic math you don't need to
have a lot of background in math to make
sense of this so we're going to use this
exact form and understand binary numbers
if you look at what we have here we have
a few binary numbers that are made up of
ones and zeros that's why it's called
binary because you can only have two
states or zero or one in your numbers so
we can really do the same thing we are
in base two so instead of using a ten
here we're going to be using a two but
it is the same operations we really did
if you take this and multiply and add
these things up what you're going to end
up is a base 10 representation of this
number if we go in the middle here we
have something we can easily do without
using a calculator the expression on the
left here is going to evaluate to
zero because we are multiplying with
zero the second one is going to be a two
because we are taking one and
multiplying this by two the others are
going to be zeros but the last one is
going to be 2 to the power of 4 which is
16 and we're going to add a 2 and this
is going to evaluate to 18. we can
actually bring up our calculator on
windows 10 i think it can help in this a
little bit we're going to bring it up
and we want to put it in a programmer
mode and we're going to go back on our
slide and find our number which is one
zero zero one zero so we're going to
type it out one zero zero one zero in
binary this is binary that we have typed
here so let's clear this and do one zero
zero one zero and you're going to see
that in the decimal it is 18 which is
what we came up by computing this in our
brain let's try the one we had before
that we couldn't really do in our brain
we're going to say one zero zero one
zero one let's do that we're going to
clear one zero zero one zero one this is
going to evaluate to 37 in decimal and
you can use calculators like this to
really do the transformations between
these different number representations
okay down below we have a one one one
which is going to evaluate to a seven in
base ten okay if we have three digits we
can really represent numbers between
zero and seven and you see a table here
that is going to prove that zero zero
zero is going to evaluate to zero in
decimal zero zero one is going to be a
one and if you go down to one one one
that is going to evaluate to a seven you
can try and use a calculator to prove
this and really understand how this
works if we use the three digits
representation our numbers are going to
look something like this in memory we're
going to take the bits in memory and
group them in groups of three and we are
going to use binary to actually make
sense of these numbers for example here
on the left this is going to be a one
the second one from the left is going to
be a six and this is going to be a six
as well this is going to be a zero this
is going to be a three because we have
one and two here we add those up we get
a three if this doesn't make sense you
can try and use a calculator you're
going to see that it makes sense okay so
what if we want to group our digits in
groups of four we can do that and we're
going to end up with something like this
the values we can represent are going to
go from 0 all the way to 15 and you can
try and prove this using the calculator
like we just did and it is going to look
like this in memory so what we really
are doing is grouping the bits in
different sizes of data and we have a
kind of formula that we can use to make
sense of the data in memory for example
on the left here we have zero one one
zero if we go back to our table and
defined zero one one zero this is a six
and we're going to know that these four
bits here are really storing s6 and
there are ways you can manipulate this
in your c plus plus program we're going
to see that you can also use five digits
and you're going to end up with
something like this and the numbers are
going to go from 0 all the way to 32 and
this is how it's going to look in memory
you can try and come up with what this
represents in decimal i'm not going to
tell you this but we can try and figure
out the one on the left here so it is 0
1 1 0 1. if we go back we're going to
come up to 0 1 1 0 1 which is a 13 here
so this memory location these five bits
represent a 17 number so if we want to
kind of generalize what we have talked
about in the last slides if you have one
digit you can really represent two
states zero and one if you have three
digits you can represent numbers between
zero and seven and you can go all the
way down and if we generalize this in a
mathematical formula we can say that if
we have n digits we're going to be able
to represent between 0 and 2 to the
power of n minus 1. and if you try to
plug in any number of digits you're
going to see that this formula works
okay so these are a few grouping of bits
we have in practice we can use eight
digits and we can represent numbers
between zero and two 255 if we have 16
bits we can represent this range if we
have 32 bits we can
represent this range if we have 64 bets
we can really represent a really huge
range i can't even say this number it's
really bad okay now you should have a
pretty good idea of the binary system
and different representations we can use
to make sense of binary numbers in a
computer's memory the last thing i want
you to see is what we call hexadecimal
number system and it is a technique we
use to shorten the length of how we
represent a binary number in memory how
does it work well we take our number and
split it in groups of four bets and each
group is assigned a symbol we can use to
represent it if we have four zeros
that's going to mean a zero in
hexadecimal if we have zero zero zero
one we're going to represent a one and
you can see that if we go up to nine
this is really similar to what we have
in the decimal number system but once we
hit 10 we're going to represent that
with an a in hexadecimal 11 is going to
be b 12 is going to be c 13 is going to
be d 14 is going to be e and 15 is going
to be f so how do we use this to
represent binary numbers let's see an
example here we have a huge number that
we represent in memory it starts with
zero and ends with the one here so the
first thing we're going to do is to
split this in groups of four and the one
on the left is going to be a one one one
one if we come back to our table here
one one one one means f so we're going
to represent this with an f if you go to
the second group of four bets we have
zero zero one one if we go back zero
zero one one means three so we're going
to have a three here i hope this makes
sense and we're going to keep using the
same transformations and we're going to
come up with one f 0 3 e 6 and we can
represent this binary number using these
symbols you can see that we go from
using 32 bits to using one two three
four five six seven eight symbols to
represent this and this is shorter and
easily manipulable by humans and we use
a zero x in front to mean that this is a
hexadecimal number i really hope this
makes sense so if we have numbers that
don't really fit in groups of four we're
going to go from the left and split this
in groups of four and we're going to end
up with a group on the left that doesn't
really meet our requirements and what we
can do is add the missing bits and make
them zeros and we call this operation
padding this is what you can do to
really represent any number in
hexadecimal if you don't have enough
bits on the left we also have another
system that is really not widely used
today but i am mentioning it here for
completeness it is called octal system
it goes from zero all the way to seven
and we can divide our binary number into
groups of three and represent using
these zeros and ones to shorten the
length of the binary number we can
really do the same thing we did with
hexadecimal so we're going to take our
binary number and divide this in groups
of three the one on the left is going to
evaluate to a 7 because it's 1 1 1 and
one one one evaluates to seven in octal
system the second one is also going to
be a one one one the third one is going
to be one zero zero if we go in our
table it's going to be one zero zero
it's going to be a four and you see we
have a 4 here and you can do the same
things until you have figured out the
entire number here and you see on the
left we are doing padding and adding a
missing bit and making it to 0 so we are
coming up with 0 0 1 and if we go back
to our table here 0 0 1 is a 1 and
that's what we put here so we're going
to put this number here it's going to be
15 61 41 70 47 7 and we're going to add
a zero in front to mean that this is a
number represented in the octal system i
really hope this makes sense okay so we
have seen all these binary numbers and
different number systems we can use to
represent them but how do we use them in
a c plus plus program well i'm glad you
asked here is a simple example of how
you can represent the number 15 through
different number systems in c plus plus
if you just say 15 like this it's going
to be in decimal if you add a zero in
front it's going to mean that the number
is in octal system so this can be
confusing sometimes if you do 0 17 it's
not going to be 17. so if you say 0 17 c
plus plus is going to interpret this
number as if it is in octal system and
it is going to turn this into 15. down
here you see the same representation in
hexadecimal we saw that you use a 0x in
front to represent that it is in
hexadecimal and this is going to be 15
in memory and here we have
representation in binary using zeros and
ones and you use zero b in front like
this i have to say that this was only
possible since c plus plus 14. so if you
are using an older standard of c plus
plus you want to be able to represent
binary like this and if we run this
program it is going to print the same
thing it is going to print 15 but we
stored the number using different number
systems let's go to visual studio code
and try this out okay here we are in a
folder i have on my system where i am
going to be storing my projects for this
chapter the first thing i am going to do
is copy code from a template project i
am going to go in and copy things over
and i am going to put these in 4 2
number systems i am going to open this
folder in visual studio code so i am
going to go to file close the folder we
have now and i am going to open up a new
one open folder and i am going to browse
to the location of my project i am going
to open this project here that says
number systems we are going to get rid
of the welcome screen and open our main
cpp file we're going to get rid of this
constival thing and clear everything we
have in the main function here the first
thing we want to do is to store an
integer that is 15 and we're going to
say and number one the exact same thing
we had in the slides and we're going to
store 15 in this variable here this is
going to be represented in decimal and
if we want to store the semi number in
octo we saw that in our slides we could
store this as 0 17. so let's do that
we're going to say it number 2 and we're
going to store in 0 17. this is not
going to be 17 this is going to be a
representation of a number in octo
system so we're going to say that this
is octo and we can represent the number
in hexadecimal as well so we're going to
say it number three and it is going to
be
0x because it is hexadecimal and we're
going to say zero f this is how we
represent it you can use lowercase or
uppercase it won't really matter let's
use uppercase here and we can use binary
because we are using c plus plus 20. so
we're going to say and number four and
we're going to store in a representation
of 15 in binary and it happens to be
four zeros and four ones and we have to
prefix this with a zero b this is how it
works so this is going to be in binary
and if we print all these numbers up
we're going to see let me not tell you
this what do you think we'll see okay so
i went ahead and typed this out what do
you think we will see when we build and
run this program before we do that we're
going to open a terminal so that we see
it here and we're going to go to
terminal run task we're going to build
with gcc let's wait and see if the world
is successful world finished
successfully we have a rooster program
in here we're going to
click somewhere in this terminal and our
terminal is going to show up if we do
dur you're going to see that our rooster
program is here and if we run it i want
you to take a moment and guess what
we're going to see hmm number one 15
number 215 in number 315 and number four
15. this is really the same number we
are storing in these variables but we
are using a different representation
that is going to be convenient depending
on whatever it is we are doing if it is
more convenient to use binary we are
going to use binary if it is more
convenient use hexadecimal please do use
hexadecimal but the representation of
this number in memory is really going to
be the same i really want you to take
some time and let this sink in because
you're going to see these things a lot
of times in your career as a software
developer so please do yourself a favor
and make sure you really understand this
okay this is really all we set up to do
in this lecture trying to make sense of
the binary numbers we have in memory and
how we transform between them and
different forms of data that is easily
manipulable by humans all data is
represented by a bunch of grouped cells
of zeros and ones we have seen this as
the range of your data grows so will be
the number of digits you need to
represent the data in memory we have
seen that the hexadecimal system makes
it a little easier for humans to handle
streams of data in ones and zeros octo
has the same goal as hexadecimal but
it's almost no longer used in modern
times i just mentioned it here for
completeness we are going to stop here
in this lecture in the next one we're
going to look at integers in a little
more detail so go ahead and finish up
here and meet me there in this lecture
we're going to learn a little more about
integers in c plus plus integers are
represented by ant and z plus plus it's
what you see on the left here and they
are used to store whole numbers things
like 1 2 and 3. they typically occupy 4
bytes or more in memory but in most
times it's going to be 4 bytes so for
example if you have a variable called
age and it is an integer this is how
it's most probably going to look in
memory it's going to take four bytes and
i really want to make it clear what a
variable is it is a named piece of
memory that you use to store specific
types of data okay so here if we have a
variable named age it is a named piece
of memory edge is going to be the name
of that piece of memory and we can store
data in that memory it's going to look
like this in memory but the value is
going to be stored in here in binary
format i really hope this makes sense a
variable is a named piece of memory that
we can use to store different kinds of
data and okay now we're going to look at
a few examples of how you can work with
integers in your c plus program you can
define a few variables here we have one
that is going to store the number of
elephants we have you can declare it
like this and not put in a value and if
you do it like this the compiler is just
going to put in some garbage value that
is really not meaningful for your
program so you see the warning we have
here as a comment the variable may
contain random garbage value and this is
something you need to be aware of
another way we can define integers in
our c plus plus program is this
statement here that declares a variable
called lion count it's going to
initialize to zero if we use curly
braces like this it's going to
initialize to 0 by default we can also
explicitly put in a value we can do the
same with cat count and we can use these
variables to do operations for example
we can declare another variable and it
is going to store the number of
domesticated animals and we're going to
add up the numbers for dogs and cats and
we're going to store the result of that
in our variable that is called
domesticated animals this is something
you can do another thing that can be
problematic is trying to use variables
that you haven't defined or declared in
your program that is going to give you a
compiler error and the compiler is
basically going to say i don't know what
doesn't exist one here is i don't know
what this doesn't exist to is it is not
defined anywhere in the program another
thing you can do is try and store a
fractional number in a variable that you
declared as an integer and this is going
to give you a warning because fractional
numbers are usually bigger in size than
integers and this is going to lose some
of your data we don't really have enough
tools to understand this now but we are
going to understand this a little bit
later in the course but this is
something you can do you can take a
fractional number and store that in an
integer variable and we're going to do
an example and see how this behaves with
our compiler that is gcc10 okay here we
have mostly used curly braces to
initialize our variables but we can also
use parenthesis and this is going to be
usually referred to
as functional variable initialization
because we are using parenthesis and
this is mostly going to do the same
thing we saw in the last slide with
curly braces but when we come to the
example here where we are storing a
fractional number this is going to
silently chop off the data you have in a
fractional number and turn that into an
integer and this is called implicit
conversions but if we go to the last
example here where we are storing 2.9
into an integer this is going to take
this fractional number chop off the
decimal point and only store 2 in this
integer and this might not be what you
want and it is going to happen silently
so this is a really bad way to do this
if you want to do something like this it
is preferable to use curly braces
because you are either going to get a
warning that this is going to lose you
data or you're going to get a compiler
error and the compiler is going to
completely stop you from doing this and
again if any of this doesn't make any
sense we're going to go in visual studio
code play with us and see how the
compiler behaves with these things we
have another way we can initialize our
variables in surplus plus we can use
assignment and we have done this a
couple of times in the course but this
is something you can do and we are going
to play with this in visual studio code
in a minute and you're going to see how
it works okay by now we have seen three
ways we can initialize our integer
variables we can use breast
initialization which is basically using
curly braces we can use functional
notation which is using the parenthesis
and we can use the assignment
initialization which is what we have
here another thing i really want you to
see is that it is possible
to query for the size of your variable
here we are trying to print the size an
integer is going to take on our
operating system and compiler and if we
try to run this on our compiler it's
going to tell us exactly how much memory
an integer occupies in our program we
can either pass and explicitly like this
or we can pass a variable name and it is
going to work equally well okay ants are
mostly going to take up four bytes in
new memory so here we have a
representation of three ants in memory
if we go from this zero to this zero
this is going to be exactly four bytes
and this is how it may look in memory
one other thing i haven't really talked
about on purpose is that there are a few
rules you have to follow to name your
variables in c plus plus one of those
rules is that a variable must start with
a letter like a b c d up to z or an
underscore you can't start a variable
for example with a number that's going
to be a problem after the first
character in your variable name you can
really put in anything you can put in
numbers you can put in letters you can
really put anything you want but the
first one can't be a number variable
names are also case sensitive so if you
have a variable called bike account with
the lowercase b
and you have another one that starts
with uppercase b
these are going to be two different
variables and uh you have to be aware of
this no spaces or spatial characters are
allowed in your variables you can use
underscores but you can't use something
like plus because that's going to be
confusing to your compiler and these are
a few rules you really need to be aware
of and you're mostly going to be fine
the general form for declaring and
initializing your variable is what you
see here you're going to pass the type
in this case we have used and because we
are learning about ants you're going to
pass the variable name and you're going
to put whatever it is you are
initializing your variable with of
course this is braced initialization
because it is using curly braces but you
can also use functional initialization
or assignment initialization and it is
going to work equally well okay now we
have enough information to go in visual
studio code and play with us okay here i
am in my folder for the projects of this
chapter i am going to hop over in my
template project and copy the files that
i need i am going to go up again
and go on the project that is called
integer types
i am going to go in and paste in my
files and i am going to open up this
folder in visual studio code i am going
to close the welcome screen here and
open my main cpp file
and i am going to do the usual take out
the things we don't need to save on time
i am going to put in a piece of code
that i have lying on my drive and we're
going to
go through it to save on typing time i
don't want you to suffer watching me
type this the first thing we have is the
elephant count this is a variable that
is not initialized so this is going to
contain garbage data it's not going to
contain anything that is useful to us
but some compilers are going to usefully
put in a zero because that's a logical
number to put in here if you didn't
explicitly put a number in here the
second one is using curly braces and
this is going to automatically
initialize to zero the third one is
going to be explicitly initialized with
the 10 and the cat count is going to be
initialized with 15. you can try and
print this out and see what you come up
with after compiling this application
another thing we have seen is that we
can do something like this and put an
expression into our curly braces and the
value this evaluates to is going to
initialize this domesticated animals
variable and now you should know that
this is probably going to take 4 bytes
in memory because it is an integer
this is really how c plus plus works
each fundamental type has
a size associated to it
most times so integers is mostly going
to be four bytes on your system and
we're going to query this a little later
in this video okay let's try and compile
this program and see if it actually
works we're going to start world and you
see that the world is successful another
thing we can do is try and use variables
we haven't really declared in our
program and you can guess what is going
to happen if we try to do
and new number for example and putin
doesn't exist you know it's a number
that doesn't exist the compiler is not
going to know what this is because we
didn't declare a variable called doesn't
exist if you try to compile this you're
going to get a problem you see that we
have a problem before we even compile so
visual studio code is this smart it can
analyze our code before we compile it
and give us hints to problems that might
come up you see here it is saying
doesn't exist isn't defined so if we try
to compile this we're going to get an
error that we expect it's going to say
doesn't exist doesn't really exist i
don't know what that is so you shouldn't
really do that you shouldn't try to use
variables you haven't declared this is
braced initialization
we can also do functional initialization
as we have seen
okay another thing we can do is store a
fractional number in an empty variable
and we're going to see what this does
we're going to try and compile this code
you see we have a 2.9 we're trying to
store this in an integer if we try to
compile this let's try and use gcc let's
clear this let's bring up a terminal and
try to build this we're going to try and
run our gcc compiler on this program it
is going to say errol narrowing a
conversion of
2.899 from double to integer c plus plus
20 isn't even going to allow this so
this is a good thing because you might
think that you have a 2.9 and some
compilers are going to chop this off and
store a 2 instead so this is one of the
safe things about this way of doing
thanks so i am going to comment this out
because otherwise our program wouldn't
compile now that we know how to use
these things we can try to print the
values in here okay i am going to put in
a piece of code i have lying around on
my drive i am going to remove these
spaces inside because it is annoying
let's do this and if we try and build
this program it should compile
successfully and if we run it we should
see our numbers we're going to go in our
terminal here and do der and we're going
to run rooster and we're going to see
elephant count is one because this is a
garbage value so it could really be
anything
lion count should be zero
dog account should be 10
cat count should be 15 it is what we
have and a domesticated animal count is
25 because we have drug account
and we add that to cat count and we're
going to end up with 25. this is what we
expect now that we know how to work with
this we can also try and play with
functional initialization before i put
in my code i am going to comment all
this out because i don't want this to
disturb us as we work with our
functional initialization code so i am
going to comment all this out and go all
the way down and put in my code for
functional initialization
and you see here we have a variable
called ethel we initialize this to 5 we
have orange count which is 10 we have
fruit count
and we have a bad initialization that is
not going to work it doesn't exist 3 and
doesn't exist 4 don't really exist so so
this is going to give us a compiler
error
and if we do something like we do in
narrowing the conversion function here
this is mostly going to compile and this
is going to chop off data and store a 2
instead of the 2.9 this is something you
should really be aware of and you see
the comment here says information lost
this is less safe than braced
initializer because breast initializer
is going to
give you a compiler error if you try to
do this and that's a good thing
so we also try and print these out so i
am going to tidy this up a little bit
and i am going to try and compile this
piece of code run task and world with
gcc the world is going to pass through
without a problem
and if we do clear and run rooster we're
going to see apple count is 5 which is
what we have in here orange count is
going to be 10 so this is right fruit
count is going to be 15 because it is 5
plus 10
and what is really worrying is that
narrowing conversion is 2 but we didn't
store in a 2 we started in a 2.9
and because an integer can really store
4 bytes 2.9 is more than 4 bytes and it
is going to store what it can and it is
going to chop off this 2.9 and only
store in a 2 so this is really something
you should be aware of sometimes this is
going to cause problems in your program
and
really really if you are trying to store
fractional numbers in an integer please
use a braced initialization
form because the compiler is going to
stop you from doing this if you try okay
so this is really the difference between
functional notation and breast
initializer notation functional notation
is not going to give you an arrow if you
try to store something that can't really
fit in a net it is going to silently
chop it off and put in whatever it can
and braced initializer is going to give
you a compiler error so this is the
difference between these two okay i am
going to comment this out as well and i
am going to put the starting comment
here and i am going to go down and show
you that you can do assignment
initialization as well i am going to put
in my code here because i don't want to
type it really and i am going to print
all this out and we have a bike account
variable that we initialize using the
assignment notation track count is going
to be seven fake account is going to be
bike account plus track count and we're
going to be narrowing conversion here
and we're going to see if this actually
works we're going to try and weld this
we're going to run the task to world
with gcc
it is going to pass through you can
guess what we're going to see if we run
the program
bike account is 2 track count is 7 which
is what we expect vehicle count is nine
and uh the narrowing conversion is also
chopping off what we have here so this
is something you need to be careful
about another thing i want you to see is
that you can check the size of your
variables in memory so we're going to
check the size
with
size of
and i am going to put in a piece of code
to really play with this i don't want to
type all this because it's really
self-explanatory by now we're going to
print sites of ant and inside we're
going to say size of ant and this is
going to give us how much memory is
really occupied by an end and we can use
this form here by passing in a variable
name track count is a variable we have
declared and initialized here
so if we build this program
let's do that with gcc the build is
going to pass through and if we run
rooster we're going to see that the size
of int is four you're going to see that
this is in bytes and size of track count
is for as well because track account is
also an integer so these are all little
tools you can really use to
know how much memory is really being
used and occupied by your program and
this is really all we set up to do in
this lecture to learn as much as we can
about integers integers occupy 4 bytes
in memory for the most part and we have
seen different ways we can initialize
our integer variables we can use breast
initializers which is going to use curly
braces we can do functional
initialization using parentheses like
this we can also do assignment notation
using the from like this and we can use
size of to check the size of our integer
variables i have to say that these kinds
of initialization also work on other
variables but we took the chance to
introduce all these concepts using
integers this is really all we set out
to do in this lecture i hope you found
it interesting we are going to stop here
in this lecture the next one we're going
to start and learn about integer
modifiers go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about integer modifiers and these are
little things you can sprinkle around
your integer types to modify their
behavior a little bit but before we dive
deep into this
let's talk about how we can store
positive or negative numbers in integers
and we can do something like this if we
put a tan inside our value 1 variable
which is an integer
it's going to work we can also put in a
negative number like minus 300
and it is going to work so what's the
magic here
well
this is signed by default and this is a
modifier we can apply to our variable
to signal that we have the possibility
to store in negative or positive numbers
and it is going to work if you only want
to store positive numbers in your end
variables you can use another
modifier called unsigned and if you put
in a negative number you're going to get
a compiler error we're going to see how
this works in a minute okay regardless
of whether your integer variables are
unsigned or signed they are going to
still occupy 4 bytes in memory so this
is how it's going to look in memory and
here is a simple formula we can use to
come up with
the range of values we can store in our
int values
if they are unsigned or signed if the
number is inside you can use this
unsigned range formula and plug in the
number of bits you have
in your data type if you are using a
signed integer
this is what you're going to use and
here is a simple example for example if
we have an unsigned and this is the
range of values we can store we can
basically go from 0 all the way to 4
billion if the number is signed the
range is going to basically be divided
into half the half is going to go on the
left and store negative numbers and the
other half is going to go to the right
and store positive numbers and you can
see that we can basically go from minus
two billion to two billion if the number
is signed okay by now we have seen two
modifiers unsigned and designed but
there are others for example you can
flag your integer types as short or long
what does this do well this is a table
that i put together to try and come up
with all the combinations you can come
up with if you have a short variable it
is going to be two bytes in memory this
is the modification that this modifier
does to your type if you have short and
it's going to be two bytes if you have a
signed short and it's going to be two
bytes if you have unsigned shirt and
it's going to be two bites you can see
that the effect of short is really
shortening the original size in memory
for whatever type you applied this on
this is really working on an editor even
if we don't specify int here for example
short short here it's going to
implicitly be and that's why
we have two bytes because it's basically
an end that we have split into here in
the second column we have ant which is
going to be 4 bytes if it is assigned
and it's going to be 4 bytes this is
really the sizes you're going to come up
with if you use these combinations of
modifiers on your integer types one
thing i really want you to be careful
about is that these modifiers only work
for integral types so they work for data
types in which you can store
decimal or whole numbers you can't use
this on types in which you can store
fractional numbers like 2.9 that's going
to give you a compiler error now that
you have an idea about this why don't we
go in visual studio code and actually
play with us okay here we are in our
folder that contains our projects we're
going to do the usual and copy the files
from our template project and we're
going to put those files in our integer
modifiers project here let's open it up
and paste in the files we're going to go
up again and we're going to open this up
in visual studio code the first thing i
want to play with is storing positive
and negative numbers in our integer
types so we're going to say end value
one and we're going to store in a 10 for
example and we're going to do any value
and we're going to put in a minus 300. i
think this is what we had you know a
slide so we're going to keep this
if you try to print this out so we're
going to say value 1 and we're going to
say value 2
and we're going to try and build this so
we're going to open our terminal so that
we can play with it right away
and we're going to run the task to world
with gcc the world is going to be
successful if we run our program we're
going to see that it's going to say
value 1 is 10 and value 2
is -3 300 this is really cool we can
store positive numbers and negative
numbers in our end times and this is
going to occupy
4 bytes in memory we can prove this by
printing the size of value 1 and value
2. let's do that so we're going to say
size of value 1 is size of value 1. we
can also do it for value 2 size of value
2 and it's going to be size of value two
std and yeah if we build this again
we're going to run the test world with
gcc and uh we run our application it's
going to save four bytes so it doesn't
really matter if we store in a positive
number or a negative number it's going
to be 4 bytes this is the point i want
to make here another thing you can do is
actually make it
very clear that you have signed numbers
in here and you can use the signed
integer modifier here so this is going
to give us the same result and if we try
to both again
run the task to build with gcc the world
is going to be successful if we run the
program we're going to get the same
result so if you don't put aside or if
you put it here it's going to be exactly
the same thing another thing you can do
is make it very clear that you want to
store
positive numbers in your variables we
can do that by using the unsigned
integer modifier so we're going to say
unsigned
and value three for example and we're
going to put in a four
this is going to be fine but if you do
unsigned and value 4 and put in a minus
5 for example
this is going to give you a compiler
error because you save this is unsigned
and this really means that you want to
store in only positive numbers but you
are trying to put in a negative number
if you try to build this let's try this
we're going to run the task to build
with gcc we are going to get a compiler
arrow saying conversion from -5 to ant
this is not allowed you're going to get
a compiler arrow your program is not
going to compile so this is a compiler
error let's say this here and this is
really all i had to share about these
signed and unsigned modifiers
signed is going to mean that you can
store negative and positive numbers
unsigned is going to mean that you can
only put in positive numbers and if you
try to put in a negative number you're
going to get a compiler error now that
this is commented out if you try to run
the test to world with gcc
the world is going to be good and we
will be able to run our program
and it's going to do whatever it was
doing before as we see here we also saw
that we could use the short and
long modifiers and we're going to put a
piece of code here that is going to
allow us to play with them so i don't
want to type this and if you don't want
to type this as well you can get this
code from the resource section it's
going to be left you can open the link
use the code copy the code and paste it
in here and really play with it because
the point is really not to type all this
the point is to understand what these
modifiers do
to your variables what we are going to
do we're going to try to print them out
and print the size they actually have in
memory we're going to do this in four
groups we're going to do one for short
and long we're going to do one for ant
here we're going to do one for long and
we're going to do one for long long
these are things you can do and we're
going to see how much memory is actually
being used by all these variables we are
going to start with the first group here
so we're going to go down and print the
size is out and this may be really hard
to wrap your brain around but they are
plain old
see out statements that we have been
doing all along i am going to split this
on different lines so that you can
really say this so
we have an output statement for a short
var which is what we have here so we
expect this to take two bytes and all
these things are probably going to take
two bytes let's try and build the
program with gcc the bullet is going to
be successful we are going to run
rooster and you're going to see that
short end is two bytes signed short is
two bytes and everything is basically
two bytes
in this group here and we did guess
right the next thing we want to try out
is this group of ants so
we are going to go down and give
ourselves some breathing room
and we're going to paste this in and
we're going to separate these again so
that we can see what is really happening
here and i think this is really enough
so we're going to see the sizes for the
thanks we have in this group here and we
expect this to take four bytes so let's
try and run the world task to build with
gcc the world is going to be good we can
run the program like we usually do and
you're going to see that ant variable is
4 bytes and everything in that group is
4 bytes and this tells you that
regardless of the side and unside
modifiers you put here it's going to
really use the size of it here okay it's
going to take four bytes in memory let's
try this group here we are going to go
down and put in the code to print the
sizes for them
and this is what we should use
let's split this on different lines so
that it is easier on the eyes and again
if you don't really want to type this
you can get the code from the length
resource section you're going to find
the code here and you can copy and paste
and really play with us but it is
helpful to really type these things out
and really bring these things in muscle
memory because it's going to help okay
so we have this and we're going to try
and run the world task with gcc the
build is good we're going to go in here
and run rooster
and it is going to say long variable is
four bytes and everything in this group
is basically going to be four bytes
in here the last one is this long long
thing
it is going to really give you a huge
range
for your values you can store in the
variable but don't really trust my world
let's try this out so that you can see
for yourself we are going to go down and
really put this in so we're going to
give ourselves some breathing room
and paste the code in
so i am going to
bring this to the next line
and what we are really doing is printing
the sizes for the variables that we have
in this group here
let's build and see
if this passes the world
the world is going to be good
now we can run rooster
and we're going to see that long long is
eight bytes eight bytes gives us a
really huge range of values okay this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture to learn about these integer
modifiers they modify the way your
integer variables behave for example we
can specify that we only want positive
numbers all that we want to both store
positive and negative numbers for that
you're going to use designed or unsigned
modifiers you can also shorten or
lengthen the range of values you can
store in your variable by using the
modifiers short and long and from the
output of a program here you can really
see all these effects here this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
start and learn about fractional numbers
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about fractional numbers and as we
work with these numbers i want you to
keep in mind that any piece of data you
work with in your c plus program
is ultimately going to be stored in the
form of ones and zeros in memory
functional number are also called
floating types in technical terms they
are used to represent numbers with
fractional parts in c plus plus and many
other languages and we have three types
that we can use in c plus plus we have
float
double and long double and the main
difference is in the size they occupy in
memory a float takes four bytes a double
takes eight bytes and the long double
takes 12 bytes typically so as the size
goes up you can also notice that the
precision goes up so what is the
precision the precision is basically the
number of bits you can represent with
that type starting from the number in
front of the decimal point so if we look
at this number here we can try and
figure out its precision so we're going
to count 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12. the
precision here is 12.
if we go back to our table
we're really not able to represent a
number like this with a float
the smallest thing we can use to
represent this number well
is a double because the precision is 15
and it is more than what we need for
this number which is 12. one thing you
should remember is that the number in
front of the decimal point is also
counted then when you are trying to
figure out the precision for your
floating point numbers in c plus plus so
here we have an example of how we can
declare and initialize floating point
numbers in our c plus plus program
number one is a really huge number so
you can guess that this is more than we
can handle with the float we're going to
see how this is handled by our compiler
a double has a precision of 15 so we
should expect to store more numbers than
we did in a float a long double should
be able to handle this without a problem
because if we go back to our table here
our long double here should be able to
handle this better than double but it is
possible that it is the same thing as
double depending on the compiler
implementation and if we try to print
out the sizes here we're going to see
what the compiler gives us we're going
to do this when we try this in visual
studio code okay and here we are trying
to print out the precision of these
numbers we can use a special setting on
our stream to control the maximum
precision that we can see here you see
that we are trying to show the precision
for each number there is a special
setting we can put on stdc out to make
it control the precision to a given
number here we are using 20 and we're
going to see that for number one this is
going to be seven digits for number two
it should be 15 digits or something
close to that the specifics are really
dependent on the compiler implementation
and for long double it should at least
be the same as double or even more in
some cases okay here we want to see that
we can also have narrowing errors
if we try to store something back in a
float and a float can't really handle it
here we have a number with a lot of
digits one two three four five six seven
eight nine and we know that the float
can only handle seven digits so
this is probably going to give us a
compiler error as we've seen for breast
initialization if we use functional
initialization this problem is not going
to be code at compile time so we're
going to end up with a chunked piece of
data and we're going to see this when we
play with this with visual studio code
and another format we can use with
floating points is that we can use
scientific notation and it is basically
a way we can use a power of 10
multiplier to multiply with our floating
point number so for example here number
5 is going to be this number 1 9 2 4 0 0
0 23 we can use a floating point
scientific notation to represent this
so what we're going to do we're going to
say 1.9 and we're going to multiply this
with 10 to the power of 8. this is what
this means this 8 here means to multiply
with 10 to the power of 8. and if we
multiply with that that basically means
moving the decimal point 8 digits to the
right so we can go one two three four
five six seven eight and it is going to
end at these three here and it is going
to be basically the same number number
seven is also another one and if we do
this we're going to pad with zeros after
these four and we're going to end up at
this same location as the three but it
is going to be a zero we're going to see
about that in a minute and number eight
is another floating point number and we
can use scientific notation to represent
it just like you see with number nine
we're basically going to have the same
thing when we have a minus in here it
means we're going to multiply with 10 to
the power of minus 11 and this is going
to give us a number below one thing zero
point zero zero seven or something like
that so we're going to go 11 digits
after the zero here and if we count one
two three four 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 and the
decimal point is going to go after three
and we're going to basically end up with
the same thing here we're going to play
with this in a minute and you're going
to see that all this makes sense and
don't forget that any piece of data we
store in a computer is going to be
ultimately represented by ones and zeros
in memory and for floating points we
don't use the number systems like we've
done for integers there is a special
system that is used to do that but it is
a little bit complicated to cover in a
course like this i am just going to
point you to it if you are interested
and when you are done with this course
you can come up and read on this the
main point is that any piece of data
that you represent in your c plus plus
program is going to be represented in
terms of ones and zeros in the memory of
your computer okay there are a few
things you can do with floating points
that you can't really do with integers
for example you can divide with zero if
you take a floating point number and
divide that with zero you're going to
get what we call infinity if the number
is positive you're going to get positive
infinity if the number is negative
you're going to get negative infinity
and you can take two floating point
numbers that are zeros and divide them
and what you're going to get really is
not a number it's something called nan
which stands for naughty number
and uh your program is going to not
crash but very few things you can't do
with these things for example you can't
add them up you shouldn't really do this
it's probably going to end up bad for
your program here we have a few examples
we have three numbers declared they are
doubles they must be occupying eight
bytes in memory number 10 is initialized
to 5.6 11 is initialized to zero because
we are using the braced initialization
and we have nothing in here
and infinity here is the result of
dividing a number by zero so it's going
to be positive infinity because number
10 is a positive number if you go down
we're going to print number 10 divided
by number 11 and we're going to say
yields we're going to put the result out
we're going to see that down here on the
second line you see that we are trying
to add something to infinity and this is
also going to yield infinity because
think of infinity as something super big
and if you add something small to
something big it's still going to be
something big down here you see that
result equals number 11 divided by
number 12 and these two are zeros so
we're going to end up with none and
that's what we're going to print in this
statement here
down to the bottom okay you should
really remember to put in the suffixes
when you are initializing your floating
point numbers otherwise the default is
going to be double this is what we mean
by this you see this floating number we
have a suffix that is f to mean that it
is a floating number if you don't put
that in this is going to be interpreted
as double and the compiler is going to
try and turn that into a float by
chopping off things that can't really
fit in a float so to really make it
clear that you are stirring in and
loading number please put this f suffix
here for double you don't need to put
anything because it is the default
assumed by the compiler but for a long
double you have to suffix this with l
just like this so that's what we really
mean here we have seen that the
precision for float isn't really enough
for many of the computations we might
want to do in our c plus plus
applications okay we have talked a lot
about floating point numbers let's head
to visual studio code and actually play
with them okay here we are in our folder
that is going to contain our project the
project is going to be called fractional
numbers so we're going to copy our files
go up a little bit
and put those in and i'm going to go up
again and open this in visual studio
code we're going to close whatever it is
we have opened now we're going to close
folder and we're going to open our
project in visual studio code and we're
going to do the usual and remove things
we don't need in here the first thing we
want to do is to store a few floats in
our program we're going to declare and
initialize a few floating point numbers
we have number one number two and number
three and we want to make it clear that
the sizes are what we expect we are
going to open a terminal window here and
we're going to build with gcc run the
task to weld with gcc the world is going
to be successful we're going to come to
our terminal click a little bit and
we're going to type dir we're going to
see that a program is in place if we run
it we are going to see that size of
float is 4 size of double is eight and
size of long double is 16. this is what
we expected another thing we can do is
try and play with the precision of these
numbers and see what we can really go
away with okay so we're going to
actually put in a piece of code to play
with this we're going to add a setting
to our sddc out stream so that we can
control the precision but for this to
work we need to bring in a library that
is called i o manip so we're going to
include that i o manip and how do i know
this i usually consult the c plus plus
standard library documentation and you
are not at the point where you can
really understand it right now so we're
going to be putting in these things here
and explaining them as we go and i made
the type here it is io manip and you see
that
now this is recognized our program
should compile so we're going to try and
weld it so that we can try this out
we're going to build with gcc the world
is going to go through we can run our
program we're going to do dur and clear
and rooster to run you see that things
start to go off at sex and if we count
what we have here it is one two three
four five six seven we can only
represent seven numbers accurately with
a float and after that we're just going
to have garbage because the computer
can't really make sense of whatever we
have after our
seven digits that we can legally
represent with the flood so the
precision for our floating point number
here is seven i really hope this makes
sense let's check out number two
we are using double so precision should
be around something like 15. so we are
putting in a number one through nine and
we are starting over zero one two three
four five up to zero again if we look at
what we have in the output here we have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine zero
one two three
four five six and here things start
falling off after our sixth year and if
we count we're going to have 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 digits
this is the precision we are having this
compiler for double 17 so it is
something around 15 and we should expect
to have something more than that or at
least the same thing as double with long
double so if we look at this you see
that it is one two three four five six
seven eight nine zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine we are able to
represent up to 20 and you can see that
long double leaves up to even the
precision of 20 that we have set with
std set precision here okay i really
hope now that you have an idea about
these precisions we have with our
floating point types in c plus plus
programs another thing i want you to see
is
what kind of narrowing errors we can get
if we try to initialize with something
that can't really be represented by a
floating point number and here we have a
float it is called number four and we
are trying to put in something that is
bigger than we can really fit in it has
more than seven digits so one two three
four five six seven eight nine it is
more than seven digits and we would
expect to have a problem with this
because we are using braced
initialization let's try and build this
with gcc we're going to do that and this
is going to work successfully so this is
going to silently chop off our number if
we try to print it out we're going to
say sddc out number four and we're going
to world again run the test tube world
so that our changes are taken into
effect i'm going to do dur and do
rooster and this is going to print our
number you're going to see that after
the zeros
we have junk our number has been
basically chopped off and this is junk
because we can't really represent this
with the double the 16 here has been
chopped off because we can't basically
represent this with the floating point
number if we change this to double this
is going to probably give us what we
expect so let's run again world with gcc
the world is going to be good if we run
the program it is going to show us the
same thing okay this is a really good
learning change why are we having the
same results as
before even if we changed the type to
double try to think about it the reason
is the suffix here is still saying f and
this is going to be stored as float in
memory so if we want this to really be
treated like a double we can take out
the float here
and if we build again and run the
application now you're going to see that
we see the 23 this is basically being
correctly stored as a double this is a
really good thing you should keep in
mind if you don't put in your suffixes
here the number is going to be
interpreted as double
by now i hope you see that if you really
try to put more than your floating point
can handle
the number is going to be chopped off
and only the precision that it can
handle is going to be stored in i hope
this makes sense and you see that the
behavior for numbers is really different
we got the compiler error when we try to
do narrowing conversion with integers
but now it is silently chopping off our
number if we try and use functional
notation i think we're going to get the
same result and change this back to a
float and uh use float here and if we
both again let's go to terminal run task
use gcc we're going to run this
let's run rooster and you see that we
get the same results our 23 is chopped
off here we can also use the assignment
notation here just like we did with
integers and this is going to do exactly
the same thing it is going to chop off
the 23 here and we're going to have some
garbage which is 16 in this case if we
weld the gun the world is going to go
through and if we run we're going to see
as it's in here okay narrowing
conversions are something you should be
aware of when storing your floating
point numbers and you should really
remember to put in your suffixes here
and other thing we have seen that we
should really play with is scientific
notation
as the comment here says what we have
seen so far in floating point numbers is
fixed notation it is what we have here
but we can also use scientific notation
which is exactly what we described in
the slides and what we have here for
example is e8 and it means that we are
going to multiply this number here
with 10 to the power of 8. if you go
down here we have number 9 so we have
3.498
and we have e minus 11 and what this is
going to do is multiply with 10 to the
power of minus 11. this is how i can
represent this here and we can print
these numbers out to really play with
them to make a difference with what we
have been doing before we're going to do
sddc out and put a dividing line here
this is one way we can do this so we're
going to do stdndl
we're going to weld this so we're going
to run the attached world with gcc 10
the world is going to go through if we
do rooster we're going to see that our
number here number five is what we
expect number six is the same thing but
we used scientific notation to do this
because we took this number and
multiplied by 10 to the power of eight
number seven should be almost the same
thing but the lower 23 here is going to
be chopped off because we haven't
specified it we're just multiplying with
10 to the power of 8 so that's why we
have 0 0 here i hope that makes sense
and if you look at number 8 you see that
we stored it like this without using
scientific notation we used fixed
notation but on the terminal it's going
to be printed out in scientific notation
and this may be pretty cool the main
usage for scientific notation is to make
sense of numbers that are really huge so
the way you interpret this you're going
to
move these numbers after the decimal
points with 0 in front and it's
basically going to be like this so if
you count the zeros you have here we're
going to have 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and 11 is going to be
directly after three and you're going to
get the number here this is what we mean
and number nine was explicitly stored in
using scientific notation and you see
that we have the same thing you can play
with these things and really make sense
of them and again we didn't specify any
suffix here so these are going to be
interpreted as doubles but this is not a
problem because they are doubles here
okay we are making some progress with
this lecture which is a little lengthy
the last thing we want to do is to play
with infinity and nan
we're going to put a message here to say
what we want to do and we're going to
have number 10 which is going to be
positive we're going to have number 11
which is going to be zero number 12 is
also going to be zero
if we take 10 and divide that with 11
we're going to get infinity because we
are dividing a floating number with zero
if we try to print that out we're going
to get infinity
and we're going to get infinity for this
result here because we are trying to add
something small to infinity which is
something really big and if we all
trying to divide zero with zero in
floating point
we're going to get what is called
naughty number and if we print that out
we're going to see this in a minute
let's build this with gcc we're going to
weld successfully let's clear this out
so that we don't have noise in here and
we're going to run rooster and you see
here it says infinity and none which is
what we said here
and if we go down here it is saying
number 10 divided by number 11 and
number 11 is zero you see that here it's
going to yield infinity if we add five
to infinity we're going to get infinity
and if we try to divide a zero by a zero
we're going to get none which is really
a way to tell you that you're doing
something wrong you should really be
careful
one other thing i want you to see is
that if you turn this five into a minus
five and build again we're going to
build with gcc and we're going to run
this rooster
we're going to get minus infinity so if
you divide a positive number with zero
you're going to get positive infinity
and if you divide a negative number with
infinity you're going to get negative
infinity and this is what we see here
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you found it
interesting and again the big message is
that any data type you're going to be
handling in your c plus plus program is
going to ultimately be stored as ones
and zeros in memory and we have learned
about floating point numbers float
double and long and they have these
properties you see here and you should
use them with this in mind otherwise
you're going to have problems with your
precision make sure you are using the
correct precision that you need in your
program we are going to stop here in
this lecture the next one we're going to
try and learn about booleans go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there in
this lecture we're going to learn about
booleans booleans are types that can
store two states in c plus plots it can
store either true or false and we can
use this to really do decisions in our
program if you look in the program we
have here we have two variables declared
the data type is bull
and one is called red light the other is
called green light
and we have true and false inside one
thing we can do in c plus plus is make
decisions we can say if the red light is
true we can
print a message that says stop and if
it's not red we can print a message that
says go through we can do that and
booleans are really used in this way to
make decisions in your c plus plus
program we haven't really learned about
if statements in this course but i am
throwing this in here to really drive
the point home that we can use this to
make decisions in our program down here
we have another way we can do this we
can actually use the variable itself
without checking if it is equal to true
or false and we are going to get the
same message the point here is that if
green light is true we're going to say
the light is green if it's not we're
going to say the light is not green you
can do something like this and again the
big point here is that booleans data
types are used to store two states true
or false in your c plus plus program
okay by default if you print a boolean
that has two in it you're going to get
true and this is what you see here and
if you print one that has zero in it
you're going to get false we can change
that with a special setting that we can
apply to our std out stream and you do
that like this with std bull alpha and
we're going to play with this in a
minute you're going to see
if we try to print with this setting
applied we're going to see true on false
and not c 0 and 1 like we did before
we're going to play with this in a
minute and you're going to see another
thing you should know is that booleans
occupy
8 bits in memory they take up an entire
bite so you may think that this is
wasteful and it is but with the amount
of memory that we have today this is
really not a big problem but if you are
working on a device where memory is
really a problem there are techniques
you can use to pack even more data in a
byte and we're going to learn about that
later in the course okay so this is
really all i have to say about booleans
we're going to go to visual studio code
and play with them in code okay here i
am in the folder for my project here i
am going to do the usual and copy the
files over
and i am going to go in my project on
booleans i am going to go up and open
this up in visual studio code i am going
to close the current folder open the new
one and browse to my project this is
going to open up in visual studio code
and i am going to close the welcome
screen here i don't need it anymore
so i'm going to remove what i don't need
and we are going to play with the exact
code that we had in the slides we're
going to declare two variables one is
going to be red light the other is going
to be green light they are going to be
booleans and in red light we're going to
store a true and story false in green
light and we can make a decision like
this so try to guess what we're going to
plant in this program we're going to try
and decide and say if the red light is
true we're going to print stop
if it's not true we're going to fall in
this block here and say
go through if we look at our program in
red light we have a true so this should
really win and we should get in this
block here i hope this makes sense so
let's try and build this program to see
that it actually works so we're going to
build with the gcc we're going to run
our program and our terminal just went
away we're going to create a new one no
big deal
and uh if we do dir we're going to see
rooster.exe
we run it it's going to say stop okay so
in red light we have true the test is
going to succeed here and we're going to
fall in this block and say stop i hope
this makes sense you can try to store a
false in here
and both again going to world with gcc
if we run this program now it's going to
say go through because red light is not
true anymore this is really what we mean
when we say that we can make decisions
based on booleans in our c plus plus
code we can also try another example
we're going to say if green light is
true
we're going to say the light is green if
it's not we're going to say the light is
not green and this is another form we
can use instead of typing the entire
thing
comparing red light to true here and
again we're going to learn about all
these comparisons here
it is just because i thought that
talking about bulls without showing
tests like this is really not going to
drive the point home for you so try to
understand this as simple tests you can
do in math if one value is true i am
going to do something if it's not true
i'm going to do something else this is
what we are doing here okay this program
here is going to check if the green
light is true so we're going to look
here green light is not true so we
should fall here and print this message
that the light is not green
let's build the program the world is
going to go through we're going to run
this
and you're going to see go through and
the light is not green this is what we
have here another thing we can actually
try to see is the amount of memory that
a boolean takes up so we can use sizeof
to do that we have seen this before if
we build with gcc we're going to go
through
and we can run our program to actually
this message and you're going to see
that bull is actually going to take up
one byte in memory this is what we saw
in the slides another thing that can be
really confusing is printing out boolean
values for example here we are trying to
print great light and green light let's
go up and actually change them a little
bit for example take green light here
and make it true
and we're going to go down again and
here we are trying to print them out red
light is going to print whatever value
we have stored then and green light is
going to store whatever value we have
stored in and again true is going to be
printed out as one
and false is going to be printed out as
a zero let's try and build this we're
going to build with our gcc compiler the
world is going to be good we're going to
run this and you're going to see that
red light is zero because we have a full
sun here
and green light is going to be one
because we haven't a true here if you
try to print out boolean variables
you're going to get one and zero by
default if you really want to see true
and false there is a special setting you
can apply to htdc out and you do that by
saying stdc out std bull
alpha and you do it like this
and if you try to print again we are
going to get true and false right now
okay let's try and print again and we're
going to work this with gcc and we're
going to run this
and now you see that we see red light is
false green light is true
this is really all i had to share about
booleans in this lecture i really hope
it drives the point home that booleans
are mostly used in making decisions in
your program and that's what you're
going to be mostly using them for and
another thing is that they take up one
bite in your memory we are going to stop
here in this lecture the next one we're
going to try and learn about characters
and text
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about characters and text and we
use a data type called car in c plus
plus to represent characters and this is
basically how you use it you store in
characters like abc and here you see
that we have a r r
o w and you put your characters in
single quotes like this to mean that
they are characters if you don't do that
you're going to get a compiler error
after you have your characters declared
and defined like this you can print them
out with stdc out and we're going to see
them on the terminal car occupies one
byte in memory so it's going to take up
eight bits okay so one thing we can do
is map each value in these 256 possible
values to a character and we can do
something like this for example we can
say that
33 represents the exclamation mark
48 represents the character 0 49
represents the character 1 50 represents
the character 2 and we can keep going up
and say for example 70 represents f 71
represents g
or
112 represents p you can really use a
mapping like this and come up with
representations of your characters in
memory and this is what we do you can
learn about this encoding and on the
link here this is a real thing and it is
called the ascii encoding that takes
characters and stores them in one byte
and the data type to store these
characters in c plus plus is car if this
doesn't make sense please bear with me
we're going to play with this in visual
studio code and it is most probably
going to make sense okay it is possible
to assign a valid ascii code to
a car variable and the corresponding
character will be stored in that piece
of memory so once you have that you can
choose to interpret that either as a
character or as a number that is
something like an integer this is what
we really mean if we declare a variable
called value which is of car type 65 is
going to be stored in memory but the c
plus plus program is going to interpret
this as a character if we go back to our
table and see what is represented by 65
this is what we're going to find we're
going to find that 65 represents a
and if we print this out by default it's
going to print a it's not going to print
65 but there is a way you can take this
character value and turn that into an
integer and print it out and you see
that here we are saying value and and we
are saying static cast
and and in the parents we have a value
this is basically a way to say we wanted
to take the value and interpret that as
an integer and we're going to learn a
little more about static cast later in
the course but it is basically a way to
transform between data types and in this
case we are trying to transform from car
to end and we're going to print this out
okay what we just described is the ascii
encoding a technique by which we can map
the first 128 numbers in
a byte two characters and use that to
represent characters this technique
doesn't work well if you have languages
like arabic japanese and chinese because
they are completely different beasts
there are better ways to represent
characters in your c plus program and
that's usually unicode but that's really
out of scope for a course like this so
i'm not going to describe that anymore
okay this is really all we need to learn
about characters we're going to head to
visual studio code and play with them
okay here i am in my working folder i am
going to go in my template project i am
going to copy things over i am going to
put that in my characters and text
project and i am going to go up and open
this up in visual studio code we're
going to close the welcome screen here
we're going to open up main cpp and
we're going to put in the code to play
with characters and text
the first thing we can do is declare
characters like this we can put in a r
r o w here and we're going to see this
printed out if we run this program we
are going to put in some code to play
with characters
we have a few variables declared that
are of car type
we go from character 1 through character
5 and these are the characters we are
storing and this is and this is the
format you're really going to use to
declare your characters after we have
them declared we can print them out like
we print any other variable and we can
try and compile this program and see
what we're going to get but before we do
that i would invite you to try and guess
so let's open our terminal
and we're going to build with our gcc
task we're going to world the build is
going to go through and if we run
rooster we're going to see that we are
printing out
a r o w we are storing our characters
and and we are able to print them out
this is really how you work with these
guys another thing i want you to see is
the size that a character occupies
in memory by that i mean card type it's
going to occupy one byte in memory and
that means that we can only have
256 different values that go between 0
and 255 if we have decided to store in
positive numbers we are using the
knowledge we learned from the integers
lecture if these calculations we are
doing here don't make sense please go
back and check that out so down here we
are declaring a character type the name
is value and we are putting in a 65. the
thing is if you try to print this value
here it's not going to print 65 it's
going to print a which is a character
representation of 65. if you remember
from our ascii table we had these
mappings between characters and integers
and 65 mapped to the character a
upper case so if we print this out this
is going to give us a but we have the
option to
interpret this as a number and we can
pass this through a static cast and it
is going to take a value turn this into
an integer and we're going to be
printing this integer on the console and
we're going to see it we're going to try
this out so we're going to run the task
to build with gcc the build is going to
go through we're going to run rooster
and you're going to see that value is a
for the first line here
and the value and is 65 because we
decided to interpret whatever is in this
value as an integer and not as a
character as it is done by default this
is really all we set out to do in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
try and learn about the auto key world
in c plus plus
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about the auto keyword in c plus
plus
this is a keyword that is going to let
the compiler deduce the type for you and
this is going to come in handy when you
have longer type names that are really
hard to type we can't really give you an
example of that because that requires to
have a good number of concepts mastered
in clause plus but we are measuring this
here for completeness because we are
talking about variables and data types
so let's hear how we can use this here
we have an example where we are saying
autovar one and what we initialize this
with is an integer so the compiler is
really going to try and guess the type
of this thing and that's the type it's
going to assign to variable one this is
what ocho is really used for if we pass
a double
inside and it is a double because we
have no
suffix here
so it is going to deduce a double if we
pass a suffix of f it is going to
interpret this as a fluid if we pass l
it is going to interpret this as long
double and if we pass in a character
it's going to interpret this as a
character and this is really the essence
of what auto is used for it is used when
you don't really want to explicitly type
the type of your variable and you want
the compiler to fill in that for you or
it gets it for you down here you see
that we have a few examples with
integers so we can make this unsigned
lung through this suffixes and the
compiler is going to deduce the type
based on what we pass in our initializer
here down here you see that we have a
few examples with integers if we pass a
suffix of u this means that we are
storing an an unsigned integer so that's
what the compiler is going to deduce if
we pass ul it is going to be unsigned
long if we pass in ll this is going to
be long long and that's what the
compiler is going to deduce here you see
that we are trying to print the sizes of
these variables and we trying to
prove to ourselves
that the compiler deduced the right type
and we are going to go to visual studio
code and actually try this out
okay here i am in my working folder i am
going to open my template project i'm
going to copy that
and i'm going to
save my files in the auto project here
so i am going to go in and put in my
files i'm going to go up again and i am
going to close whatever it is i have in
visual studio code because we're going
to create a new project i am going to
open my new folder we're going to close
the welcome screen here and we're going
to remove whatever it is we don't need
for this project
and we are going to put in the code we
basically had in the slides i am pasting
this code in to save on some time
because i don't want you to see me type
these things we're going to save some
seconds here
so the first statement here declares a
variable var1 the type we don't really
know but we're going to let the compiler
deduce that for us
and we can try and actually hover over
this and we're going to see that the
compiler already deduced that this is an
integer if we go to vira 2 this is a
double if we go to var3 you see it's a
float if you go to var4 it's long double
if you go to wire 5 it's a character you
can see that visual studio code can even
see what the compiler is going to deduce
before we even compile the code this is
the beauty of visual studio code we're
going to look at virus 6 you're going to
see that it's going to be unsigned and
if we go to var 7 it's going to be
unsigned long if we go to var 8 it's
going to be long long this is really
cool and you can see that our types are
correctly deduced visuals video code was
really helpful in showing us these types
but we want to be sure by running this
piece of code and seeing whatever size
the deduced type is for example for var1
we guessed that it's going to deduce an
end so it better be a four
in size we're going to try and run this
we're going to open our terminal here
and we're going to go to terminal and
run task we're going to build with gcc
and by the way if you want you can build
with the compiler from microsoft by
coming to terminal here and choose it
with world with msvc but gcc is my
favorite compiler and i am going to use
it if i can so we're going to hit enter
and enter we're going to see that our
rooster.exe file is in place if we run
it we're going to see our sizes so var
one occupies four bytes in memory
var2 occupies for eight bytes in memory
because it is
double fire 3 occupies 3 bytes because
it is a float var4 occupies 16 bytes
because it is a long double
and var 5 better occupy 1 byte because
it is a character and we see the same
data for
vera 6 virus 7 and var 8 and this proves
that the auto keyword is really doing
its job it is deducing the types for our
variables without us explicitly
specifying the variable type we didn't
have to do something like and or double
or whatever we can let the compiler do
that for us and this will come in handy
many times this is really all we set out
to do in this lecture and i hope you
found it interesting in the next one
we're going to look at how we can do
assignments and assign data to our
variables in a unified way go ahead and
finish up here and we'd be there in this
lecture we're going to learn about
assignments and the basic idea i really
want to drive home here is that after a
variable is initialized like we've been
doing all along you can later assign a
new value to it for example here we have
our one declared it is an integer we can
print it out and it is going to print
one two three but later in the program
we can put in another value for example
here we are putting in a 55 and if we
print var1 it's going to be 55 this time
the same idea can be extended to doubles
you see here we are doing the same thing
booleans we are doing the same thing
here the state is declared force and we
are printing that and after we are
changing this to a true value and if we
print that it's going to be true one
thing you really need to be careful
about is if you are doing auto type
deduction the type is not very apparent
by looking at the declaration of the
variable here for example here by
looking at o2 var 3 we don't really know
what that is and it is very easy to try
and put in a value that is illegal for
example here we have deduced an unsigned
integer which is only going to store
positive numbers but we are putting in a
minus 22 and this is going to be a
disaster we're going to get a compiler
error and this is going to be bad so be
careful when you are doing a type
deduction in your assignments that you
do to your variables this is really all
we have to share in this lecture let's
hop over to visual studio and show you
this in action okay here i am in my
working folder the project we're going
to be working on is four nine here
assignments i am going to grab my
template files and put that in this
folder here and i am going to open this
up in visual studio code so let's close
whatever it is we have now
and open the folder and we're going to
close the welcome screen here we don't
want it and remove whatever we don't
want from this file here the first thing
we want to do is put in the code for our
integer variable var1 and show you that
you can
assign a new value to it after it was
initialized and if we run this code
we're going to see var1 to b123 and the
second statement is going to say var1
equals
55. that's what we're going to see let's
bring up our terminal and we are going
to run the task to build with gcc
and if we hop over here in the terminal
and do dir
we're going to see that our rooster.exe
file is in here if we run it we're going
to see var one one two three var 155
exactly what we expect we have stored in
a one two three at initialization using
braced initialization here but after
later on in our program we have decided
to put a different value in this
variable here
essentially reusing it to store
something else this is the basic idea
here we can do the same things with
doubles but before we do that let's put
in a separation line so that we can see
these vents clearly in the terminal and
we're going to go down and put in our
code for a double
so we have a double variable called var2
initially it has 44.50
in and then we're going to assign a new
value to it and that's going to be 99.99
if we print that out we're going to see
that
let's work and see this in action we're
going to build with gcc
if we
run the program now it's going to save
r1 is one two three four one fifty five
but we're also going to see that viral
two starts out 44.55
but after we put in the
99.99 it's going to show up here okay
let's put in another separation line
because we're going to need that in a
minute
we can do the same things with booleans
here we are using this as just an
example but this same concept
essentially extends to any other kind of
variable you're going to have in your c
plus plus code if you initialize it with
some value you have the option to change
that value later on in your program by
assigning that value to that variable
essentially what we are doing here the
variable state which is a bull
was initialized to false we're going to
print that out and notice that we have
this setting to allow us to see true or
false instead of ones and zeros we have
seen this in a few lectures back
and later on we are assigning true to
this state and we are printing that so
if we print these things out we're going
to see false and true for the state here
so let's build
we're going to use gcc
and the world is good if we run the
program
we're going to see false and true and it
is exactly what we expect again you
really need to be careful when you are
using auto type deduction because you
might have some serious problems if you
are not paying attention let's put in
the code so that we can play with it
here we have a variable called var 3 and
the type of it is not specified
explicitly we are letting the compiler
deduce this and because our initializer
here is an unsigned integer the compiler
is going to deduce that it is an
unsigned integer the problem will come
if you try to store in a negative number
the compiler is not going to give you a
compiler arrow it is going to silently
put in some garbage value
that we don't really want in there we
want a minus 22 and you can see that
this is what the compiler is turning our
value into we want a minus 22 in this
for three but if you hover over this
minus sign here in visual studio code
you're going to see that the value that
we have in is not what we put in we put
in a minus 22 and we are getting a
really large number close to 4 billion
so this is really something that can go
silently wrong in your code and you're
going to have
a hard time trying to figure out why
your code is not doing whatever it is
you want so be careful about this let's
try and weld this so we're going to
build with gcc
the world is going to be good you're
going to see that we're not even going
to get a compiler arrow if we run this
and we're going to see that viral 3 is
exactly what visual studio could guess
and it is not good it is this value here
and the problem is that the compiler is
silently putting in a garbage value and
not what we want here because virus 3 is
basically not capable of storing
negative numbers so the compiler is
going to do its best and put in a
garbage value and this is not what you
want and you need to be aware of this
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you know about
assignments and be careful when you are
doing assignments on variables whose
types are deduced with auto and we're
going to stop here in this lecture in
the next one we're going to try and
recap what we saw in this chapter go
ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to recap what we saw in this
chapter and this chapter was really all
about variables and data types we had a
chance to look at different types that
we can use in c plus plus we saw that we
have fundamental types we can use to
represent integers floating points
booleans and we also saw that we can do
type deduction with auto we had a chance
to make it clear that data is
represented in memory as zeros and ones
and that there are some kinds of
transformations we do on these pieces of
data to turn them into a form that is
easily usable and manipulable by humans
and we saw that for integral types or
integers we could do that through number
systems and we had a chance to look at a
few number systems like binary octal and
hexadecimal and we had a chance to play
with all these variable types in visual
studio code and see the nuances of how
you really work with them i would like
to welcome you in this new chapter and
this one we're going to be looking at
operations we can do on our data and
there is a bunch of them we can add
things up we can subtract numbers we can
divide numbers we're going to see all
kinds of crazy operations we can do
on the data all the variables that we
have in our c plus plus program we are
also going to have a chance to look at
how we can format stuff when we print
them out to stdc out and we are going to
be using some utilities from the c plus
plus standard library to do some
operations on our variables this is
going to be a fun chapter i can't wait
to get started let's go in the next
lecture and start doing this
in this lecture we're going to be
looking at some basic operations you can
do
on the data in your c plus plus program
and we are going to be specifically
looking at addition subtraction dividing
numbers the modulus operator and
multiplying stuff we have seen addition
before
here we have a simple example we have a
variable called sum and we are
initializing it with two numbers that we
are adding up number one and number two
this is something you can do in your c
plus bus program you can also do
some other things for example we have
another one called other sum and we are
adding up some other numbers and we are
going to collect the result into this
other sum
variable and we're going to print these
things out so that you can see them on
your command prompt this is how you can
do addition and we're going to have a
chance to play with this in visual
studio code in a minute we can also do
subtraction we can take a number and do
minus another number like we are doing
here we're going to store the results in
this div variable and we can do some
other things
and down here you see another example in
other diff here we're going to subtract
numbers and store the result in other
def and we are also going to print this
out you can also multiply stuff this is
how you can do this you use this
operator here it is the star operator
and this is an operator that many
programming languages use to do
multiplication you should get familiar
with this and again we print out the
result so that you can see that this is
actually working we can also do division
division for integers is a little tricky
if you are seeing this for the first
time
if we take for example
31 and divide that by 10
we're not going to get fractional
numbers c plus plus is going to try and
figure out how many times it can fit 10
in 31 and we are visualizing this here
so in 31 we can only fit 10 three times
so the result of 31 is going to be three
this is the meaning here
okay with integer division you're not
going to be getting fractional numbers
this is something you should really
understand we have another operator that
is called modulus operator and this
operator is represented by this
percentage symbol that we are doing here
and the result of this operation here is
going to be what remains
after you have done the division of 31
and 10. and here the result is going to
be one and you might be wondering why
this is useful it is going to be useful
in many applications
and i think we're going to have a chance
to play with this later in the course
but right now you just need to be aware
of this operation and what it does okay
these are the operations we're going to
be learning about and playing with in
this lecture let's head to visual studio
code and actually play with this okay
here we are in our working folder for
this chapter you see that i have
prepared all the lectures we're going to
do in this chapter and i have my c plus
20 template project in place i am going
to do what we have been doing all along
so i am going to take these files and
put them
in the current lecture which is basic
operations
and i am going to paste those in and i
am going to open this folder in visual
studio code so let's do that pretty
quick we are going to close the welcome
screen here and we are going to open our
main cpp file and we are going to remove
things we don't need here the first
thing we want to play with is addition
so we're going to say that and we're
going to declare two end variables we're
going to call this number one and we're
going to put in a two for example
and we're going to do a number two
and we're going to put in a seven why
not and what we can do we can say
result equals number one plus number two
and we're going to store the result of
this operation and the result variable
here so what we can do is say sddcl and
we're going to print the result we can
try and compile this and see the result
let's open our terminal here
and we're going to build with gcc as we
always do
the world is going to go through and if
we run rooster here we're going to see
that the result of our operation is 9.
so this is how you can do addition
you can also do subtraction and here we
know to declare a new variable we're
going to store the result
in
our result variable here so what we're
going to do here is say subtraction and
we're going to say result
equals for example let's take number two
minus number one this is the operation
we want to do this is number two what we
are going to be storing in this result
here is going to be a 5 because we are
taking 7 and subtracting 2. i hope this
makes sense so if we grab this line here
and paste it in here so that we save on
some typing time
and i try to build again
we're going to
run the world task with gcc
and we're going to run rooster again it
is going to say result is 5 because we
are
taking 7 minus two here the result is
going to be five we can also do a
subtraction operation that is going to
result in a negative number so for
example we can say result equals
number one minus number two
and this is going to give us a negative
number because two minus seven is going
to be minus five so
we're going to print that here i'm going
to paste this end because i still have
this on my clipboard
if i bolt with gcc and run my program
we're going to get -5 as a result of
this operation here this is how you can
do subtraction we can also do
multiplication so let's go down here and
say that and we're going to say result
equals number one multiplied by number
two and this is the operator we used to
do multiplication in programming
languages we're going to put in our
print statement here
and we're going to world with gcc
and if we run rooster now we're going to
get 14 because we are taking
2 and multiplying that with 7. this is
how you can do multiplication
so what happens if you take
seven and divide that with two try to
give this a guess based on what we saw
in the slides we're going to go down
here and do division and we're going to
say result equals number two divided by
number one and uh
we're going to try and print this out if
we build this the world is going to go
through and if we run this we're going
to see that result is three
so to really make sense of this let's
look at these numbers we are taking
number two and dividing that with number
one so it is seven
divided by two
and because we can't store fractional
numbers in an integer the fractional
part is going to be basically chopped
off and we're going to store a three
because
two can fit in seven
only three times i really hope this
makes sense the last operation we're
going to look at is modulus
and it is a way to capture the reminder
of a division operation so we're going
to do result to play with us
and we're going to say number two and
we're going to say modulus using the
percentage operator here and we're going
to say number one
and we're going to print the result of
this and uh
take a look at this here and try to
guess what we're going to be doing what
we're doing here is really
seven
modulus
two
and we're going to take seven divide
this by two
and the reminder of that is going to be
one and that's what we're going to store
in this results variable here and if we
print that we expect to get a one here
this is what modulus does let's build
and build with gcc the world is going to
go through if we run rooster here we're
going to get a one let's do what we used
in the slide so that this really makes
sense we're going to go down here and i
do
equals 31 modulus 10. this is what we
used in the slides
so we're going to print the result here
and here we are really asking
what is going to be the reminder if we
take 31 and divide that by 10 and that
reminder is going to be stored in this
research variable so here we're also
going to get a one so let's weld with
gcc and we're going to run the program
and we are also going to get a one down
here again the modulus operator can be
hard to understand for beginners but it
is really capturing the reminder of the
division again we can see that here we
are asking how many times can 10 fit in
31 and we visualize this here it can
only fit in three times and the reminder
is going to be this red thing you see
here it's going to be one and when we do
a modulus operation here we are
interested in that reminder and that's
what we're going to be storing in
whatever variable that is capturing the
result of this modules operation
and that's what we basically have here
and this is really all we set out to do
in this lecture now i hope you have a
good understanding of these operations
you can do on integers we have used
integers here but you can really do
these operations on numbers except for
the modulus operator which is really
going to make sense for integral types
so
you can't really do modulus on floating
points or fractional numbers that's not
going to make any sense at all we're
going to stop here in this lecture in
the next one we're going to learn about
precedence and associativity a very
important concept for your operations in
your c plus plus programs
in this lecture we're going to learn
about precedence and associativity so
what do we mean by precedence and
associativity really what we mean by
this is a set of rules that we can
follow
to know what to do
when we have multiple operators in the
same expression
like in the example we have here if they
tell you to evaluate the result of this
expression
if we don't have clear rules to follow
we might have multiple answers and we
want to know which one is right or wrong
for example one might want to do a and b
first and then do c and then do d but
one might want to do e minus f
and do b multiply by c and then do
things in different ways and get
different results
hopefully you are saying that this may
be a big problem what we get from
precedence and associativity is the
rules we can follow to know which
operator we have to do first for example
in c plus plus
the multiplication and division operator
have to be done before you do addition
and subtraction and if you want to
evaluate this expression here you're
going to have to do b and c first and
then do d and e once you have those
results then you can do addition and
subtraction but the question remains
still
what do we do first if we have only
addition and subtraction in an
expiration and we solve that problem
with associativity associativity defines
if you do the operations from the left
or from the right
and again these things might not make
sense yet we're going to do an example
and you're going to really see what is
meant by this
to summarize precedence tells you which
operation you can do first and
associativity is going to tell you in
which direction you're going to go from
the left or from the right and some
operators are going to be left
associative and that means that you're
going to start evaluating them from the
left some operations are going to be
right associative and you're going to
start evaluating them from the right and
i am not making these things up there is
actually a c plus plus operator
precedence table that you can consult to
know which operators
you should do first if you really are
evaluating this thing with your mind
okay for example if you look in this
table there are many operators we
haven't seen yet but that's not the
problem the most important thing here is
to know what precedence and
associativity are and when we get to
learn about these new operators you can
come here and know where they sit in
this precedence table for example we
know how to do addition multiplication
and modulus
we see that the precedence for
multiplication division and modulus
is higher than for addition and
subtraction
and we can use this in our operators to
know
which one is going to be evaluated by
our compiler first another thing i want
you to notice in this table is this
column here on associativity if you go
back to our familiar operators here
you're going to see that
these operators are left to right so you
should start evaluating things from left
to right but some operators have right
to left associativity and when we get to
these operators you will start doing
things from right to the left okay i
think it is time we went to visual
studio code and actually played with
this thanks here we are in visual studio
code we are in our working folder we are
going to grab our template projects
we're going to copy this and put that in
our lecture on precedence and
associativity we're going to put that in
here we are going to open this project
in visual studio code we are going to
get rid of things we don't need and
remove this here in the body and we are
going to put in our test code so that we
don't have to type this and save on time
we have a few variables here a through g
and we have an expression here or a
statement
that is combining multiplication
division addition and subtraction and we
have to figure out which operation we're
going to do first
i would challenge you to do this in your
mind and try to guess what the result is
going to be before we run this in our
compiler we're going to compile this
with gcc and we are going to open our
terminal here
and if we do durham we're going to see
that we have rooster.exe
if we run it we're going to see that the
result is 30. how did we come up with
that well the precedence and
associativity table says that
multiplication and division
have to be done first
before addition and subtraction we are
going to take b and c and multiply those
so b and c multiplied we're going to get
a 24 we're going to try and do this in
our brain d divided by a we're going to
do that
so d divided by e we're going to get a 3
so we're going to have a 3 here and
after we have this we're going to do
addition and subtraction so we're going
to take a and add that to the result of
b and c so we're going to say
6 plus 24 which is the result of b and c
we're going to minus the results of d
and e and we're going to do minus here i
hope you are following and then we're
going to minus f and plus g we're going
to minus f which is 2
and do a plus g
which is 5. okay so this is our
expression here and now that we have
this we have to think about how we're
going to do this we can try to do this
from the right do two plus five and then
do three minus two plus five and go from
right to left but our associativity
table says that addition and subtraction
have left to right associativity so we
will start from the left so we're going
to do 6 plus 24 we're going to get 30
we're going to minus 3 and we're going
to get 27 we're going to minus 2 we're
going to get 25 we're going to add 5
we're going to get 30. i hope you are
following and we are really following
the rules from our c plus plus operator
precedence table here okay so this is
really how you would use this precedence
and the search activity rules to
evaluate your expressions okay here i
have another example for you so try to
evaluate what we're going to get from
this expression here
we have a divided by b divided by c plus
d minus e plus f try to do this in your
brain and try to guess what we're going
to get from the compiler if we print
this out
we're going to put in our htdc out
statement here and we're going to try
and build this with gcc of course we're
going to run the rooster and you're
going to get a 24. so how did we come up
with that we're going to start by
division and multiplication and again
where do we start do we do b and c first
or do we do a and b first well we can
check our precedence table here
and we're going to check the
associativity of multiplication and
division we're going to go to this entry
here 13 and we see that it is left to
right associative these operations here
are left to right associative so what
we're going to do we're going to start
from left and go to right so we are
going to take a and divide by b if we
take a divided by b we're going to get a
2 so let's type that here then the
result of that is going to be multiplied
by c and if we go up we're going to see
that c is eight so we're going to
multiply by eight
and get six so we can replace this with
a 16
and we should be here
then we're going to add d d is nine then
we're going to subtract
e
which is
three then we're going to add f which is
a five so we have 16 plus nine this is
going to give us 25 minus three
okay by checking this out i see that i
made a mistake
f is not
five it is a two we have here
and if we do this from left to right
because addition and subtraction are
left associative we have to do them from
left to the right we're going to take 16
and add a 9 we're going to get at 25
minus 3 we're going to get 22 plus 2 we
are going to get 24 and that's what we
have here i really hope this makes sense
okay so we have seen how we can use this
precedence table
but sometimes you want to make it really
clear which operations should be done
first
and you can do that by using parentheses
around your expressions let's grab the
first expression here and do it again
we're going to copy it
and go down
and put that in place and we're going to
store the result in our result variable
and notice that we are reassigning these
things to the result variable so that we
don't have to declare another variable i
think this is
clean and that's what we're doing here
so what we can do here is make it clear
that we want multiplication done first
by using parenthesis
and
make it clear that we want the
division to be done first
and when you do this the compiler is
going to see that you want this
operation here done first and that's
what it is going to do and if we print
result again we're going to get exactly
the same thing we had before stdc out
result
and we're going to put result out and
let's make it clear that we are using
parents here to
signal which operation we want to be
done first we can compile this with gcc
we're going to run the task to
build with gcc
and if we run the program
we're going to see that the result is 30
exactly what we had before but now it is
very clear to the reader of this piece
of code that we want b and c done first
they don't have to go through the
precedence table to really try and
figure this out potentially wasting
precious time another thing you can do
with this is for example what if the
precedence table is not working
according to your needs for example you
really want a and b
done first you can specify this with
parents here and what this is basically
going to do is going to force the
compiler to do this first it's no longer
going to do b multiply by c and d
divided by e it's going to evaluate this
first then it's going to follow the
order in the precedence table that we
have seen before so try to guess what
we're going to get now and i am going to
run the code and we're going to
go through this together so let's run
task and we're going to run rooster now
you see that the result is 72. what is
happening here well let's go through
this line by line we are doing a plus b
which is a
9 so we're going to get a nine here
we're going to put that here as a
comment then we're going to multiply
that by c
so we're going to do 9 multiply by 8 and
that's going to yield a 72
and by that time we're going to be here
and we're going to do the division first
d by e
then we're going to take nine and divide
by three that's going to yield the three
so we're going to have a three here
minus 3
we're going to minus f which is a 2 and
we're going to do plus g which is a 5.
if we evaluate this
we're going to get 72 minus 3 which is
going to be 69 minus 2 it's going to be
67 plus 2 it's going to be 72 and that's
what we have here hopefully you can see
that using the parents not only can you
make it very clear which operation you
want to be done first you can also
define the rules that are prescribed by
the precedence tables that are defined
in c plus plus i hope this makes sense
and this is really all we set up to do
in this lecture to learn a little more
about precedence and associativity
and my advice to beginning programmers
is not to rely on the president's table
too much it is to try and make your
intent very clear using parenthesis and
anyone reading your code you want to
have to go check these rules in
the reference c plus plus documentation
they are going to directly understand
what your expression is going to do and
that's a good thing readability of your
code is really something you should
strive for this is really all we set out
to do in this lecture i hope you have a
better idea about precedence
and associativity we are going to stop
here in this lecture and the next one
we're going to learn about some cool
things we can do with addition and
subtraction
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to be
learning about prefix and postfix
addition and subtraction we have an
example here and it is a simple example
we've seen a lot of times by now we have
a variable value it is an integer and we
have a 5 inside we can add a 1 to it or
we can increment it by one this is
another term we use in programming
languages when we say we are
incrementing a value we are adding
something to it in this case we are
incrementing it by one and we are
basically going to store a six and this
value here so if we print this out we're
going to get a six here
this is what we would expect we are
resetting the value to five and that we
are going to minus one or decrement by
one and the result is going to be saved
in value again so the second stdc out
statement here is going to print a 4.
this is something you should expect
now another thing we can do in c plus
plus is do something like value plus
plus here
and what do we mean by that when you use
a postfix
increment operator like this
the first thing you should know is that
this is going to increment by one it's
not going to increment by any other
value c plus plus doesn't provide a way
for you to specify another number to
increment by so value plus plus here is
going to increment by one but another
thing you should know
is that it's not going to increment
directly what's going to happen here if
you look to the top here we have a value
5 when execution hits this stdcl
statement
we are going to grab the value here so
here we're going to really print a 5 but
as soon as this statement is done the
value is going to increment by one so
the next time somebody is going to use
this value here is he's going to find in
a 6 and that's what we have here so the
first one is going to print a five
because we're going to grab the value
in here as is but as soon as we have our
value this is going to increment by one
this is what we mean by this value plus
plus here and the second statement is
going to print sx because it is already
incremented and we call this postfix
increment because plus plus is after the
value here and this is really what this
operator does and sometimes it is going
to come in handy in your c plus plus
applications we can also do the same
thing with minus minus it is going to
grab whatever value we have in this
variable so we have in a five so that's
what we're going to print here
and the next statement is going to find
it already decremented by one because
after we have our five we're going to
decrement by one that's what we are
saying here and we're going to find the
nf4 because 5 decremented by 1 becomes a
4. i really hope this makes sense ok so
what we have seen here is postfix
increment and decrement but we can also
do a prefix version of this thing if you
look at the example we have here we have
a five
and we are saying plus plus value so
this is going to increment the value
directly so as soon as this statement is
executed the plus plus value statement
here we're going to have a 6 inside and
if we print it we're going to get a 6
and this is what you see here if we go
down we are resetting our value and we
are going to
prefix increment in place
so in here we are going to increment the
value before we actually print it here
and we are also going to get a six year
i hope this makes sense and if you have
any problem with this i think if we go
in visual studio code you're going to
have a better way to say this you're
going to see the code running and make
sense of it okay so i think that
now you understand why we're going to
have these numbers printed if we go down
we can do the same thing with
decrementing we have a value here it's
five
if we
prefix decrement it it's going to be a
four here and if we print it we're going
to get a four
if you go down here we are resetting
that to five and we are going to prefix
decrement in place and this is also
going to print a four because we have a
five here and if we decrement it by one
we're going to get a four and that's
what we're going to get here okay this
is really all these prefix and postfix
increment and decrement operators are
about we are going to go in visual
studio code and actually see this
running okay here we are in our working
directory we're going to do the usual
we're going to copy code from our
template project we're going to put that
in here we're going to go up and open
this up in visual studio code so we're
going to remove things we don't need and
we're going to remove this
and we are going to put in the code we
exactly saw in the slides here we have a
value it is an integer and it is five
if we increment it by one we're going to
get a six here okay and if we print it
that's what we're going to get we are
resetting this to five and if we
decrement it by one we're going to get a
four here
so if we run this piece of code we
should have a six here printed out
and a four
down here
we're going to bring up our terminal
and build this with gcc the weld is
going to go through
and if we run the program we're going to
get the value a6 and it is four and this
is really what we expect here okay now
that this is really clear we're going to
go down and play with post fix
increment and decrement
i am going to put in a separator here so
that we can clearly see in our terminal
here and we are going to put in our test
code that we are going to use
to play with this let's bring this down
a little bit so that you can see
everything we can remove these things we
don't need them anymore okay we are
going to take the value we had we're
going to
reset that to a five
and if we value plus plus here
this is going to be a five because we're
going to capture the value as is so here
we're going to get a five
but next time we get this value it's
going to already be a sex because we
increment immediately after capturing
the value here so here we're going to
get a 5 and here we're going to get a 6.
i hope this makes sense
and if we go down here we are resetting
our value to 5 before we do any
decrementation
we are going to capture the value as is
because we are doing post fixed
decrement
and here we are going to get a 5 because
we are capturing the value as s
but as soon as we capture our value
we're going to decrement it and the
other statement here is going to get a
decremented value and that's going to be
a 4. so here we're going to print 5 6 5
4.
let's try and build this with gcc
to see that we have no problems we have
no problems the world is good if we try
to run rooster now
we are going to get the
results we had before
but uh for this code we just put in here
the value is going to be a 5 and that's
what we have here
and we're going to get a 6 which is
coming from here
after we are going to decrement and we
are going to capture the value as is
we're going to get this 5 here and for
the last statement we're going to get a
4 because the value is already
decremented and that's the for we are
seeing here
i really hope this makes sense and this
really covers
the postfix increment and decrement
operators the last thing we want to see
in this lecture is that we can also do
prefix increment and decrementation
we're going to go down here and
set up a place where we're going to be
playing with this so we're going to say
prefix
and we are going to put in our code
because i don't want to type all this
that would waste your valuable time but
i do encourage you to type these things
out and really
drill them in your brain because that's
how you're going to learn okay let's
bring this down so that we can
understand this piece of code so we are
starting by resetting our value to 5 and
notice here that we do plus plus value
this is going to increment value right
away by this time the value is going to
be six and if we print it out here we're
going to have a six printed down we're
going to reset it to five and then we're
going to implement that in place this is
also going to be printing six and if you
go down we're going to do the same
version of the same thing but we are
going to be decrementing so we're going
to decrement the value that we just
reset here
here it's going to become a 4 and that's
what we're going to print and if we go
down here we reset it again to a 5 and
we prefix decrement it in place
so the 5 here is going to become a 4
in here and that's what we're going to
print out if we build and run that's
what we're going to get we're going to
run our task to build with gcc
the build is good and if we run our
rooster application the results for the
code we just put in here are just going
to show up here
and you see that we get a six six this
is six
the other six and for the last two
statements we're going to be getting
fours and that's what we have here i
really hope that now you have a better
idea of this prefix and postfix
increment and decrement operators and
you're going to make use of them when
they really helped you design your
applications better okay so these are
your tools use them when they make sense
another thing that i want to emphasize
here is that these operators only
increment or a decrement by one you
can't make them
do things in increments of five or seven
or ten they are going to work in
increments or decrements of one we are
going to see a way we can do that with
other operators in the last lecture but
these prefix and postfix operators can't
do that and another thing that some of
you might be wondering about is if we
have the same kind of operators with
multiplication or division and we don't
have those operators in c plus plus
maybe we're going to have them in the
future when they make sense but in the
current version of c plus plus we don't
have them we are going to stop here in
this lecture in the next one we're going
to learn about compound assignment
operators in this lecture we're going to
learn about compound assignment
operators
and these are operators that allow you
to do an arithmetic operation like
addition subtraction multiplication
division and modulus and assign the
result to a value in one go let's look
at an example here we have value here
which is 45 it is an integer and we're
going to print that out but if you go
down here we are doing value plus equal
five and if you look at the comment here
this is equivalent to if you did value
equals value plus five so what this is
going to do it's going to take whatever
value is in this value here it's going
to increment that by five so that's
going to become a 50 and we're going to
store that 50 results back in this
variable here so by this time if we
printed this out we're going to get a
50. again we're going to take the value
it is a 45 we're going to add a 5 it's
going to become a 50 and we're going to
store that result back in this value
variable here it's going to become 50
and if we print here we're going to get
a 50. this is the addition version of
the compound assignment operator we also
have a version for subtraction and we
have an example of that here so it's
going to take whatever value is in this
value variable it is going to find in a
50 we're going to subtract 5 we're going
to get a 45 and that's what we're going
to store in this value here
and by the time we hit this stdc out
statement we're going to print a 45.
again we have another version for the
multiplication here so that we can
really play with all these things
we're going to take whatever value is in
here we're going to multiply that by 2
here we're going to get a 90 and that's
what we're going to store back in this
value and if we print here we're going
to get a 90
printed out we're going to go down and
do a version for a division the value is
90 we're going to divide that by 30 and
we're going to store the result back in
value here and we're going to get a 30
stored in here and if we print out
that's what we're going to get here
we also have a modulus version of this
and it works really well
here we have unit 30 we're going to take
it and do modulus 11 and what is the
reminder of dividing 30
by 11. the reminder is going to be 8
because
11 can only fit in 30 two times and
we're going to be left with the knight
because
30 minus 22 is eight and that's what
we're going to store in the value here
and if we print out that's what we're
going to get again
if you have trouble understanding this
modulus operator here please go back in
a few lectures back we had a chance to
learn about it make sure you understand
it and then come back here and this is
all going to make sense
this is really all compound assignment
is all about we're going to head to
visual studio code and actually play
with us okay here we are in our working
directory we're going to copy our
template project as we always do
and we're going to put that in our
compound assignment operators
lecture here
we're going to come up and we are going
to open this folder in visual studio
code the project is going to show up in
here and we're going to open our main
cpp file and we are going to remove what
we don't need
we are going to put in our code so that
we can start exploring this we have a 45
and this variable here which is an
integer if we print it out we're going
to get a 45
and down here
we are doing a compound addition
so what we are doing here we're going to
grab whatever value is in this variable
we're going to add a five we're going to
get a 50 and that's what is going to be
stored in here
and if we print this out we're going to
get a 50. let's put in a terminal here
so that we can see this running and
we're going to run the task to build
with gcc as we always do here
and if we run our rooster
executable we're going to get the value
is 50 and that's what we expect here
okay this is the
addition version of our compound
assignment operator and it is really
equivalent to doing this in two steps
saying value equals value plus five
you're going to get the same result if
you do that here actually let's do this
so that you don't think that i am making
this up so let's comment this out and we
are going to say volume
equals value plus five and if we build
again run the gcc task
and run the application
we're going to see the same thing we can
also go down and run the subtraction
version of this example here here we are
taking the value that we have in here
which is a 50
we are subtracting 5 we're going to get
a 45 and 45 is what we're going to store
in this value here
that's what we're going to see if we
print this out so
let's run the test world with gcc
so that our changes are reflected in our
output we're going to run this and we're
going to get a 45 this is what we expect
we are going to go down and do a
multiplication version of this
here we have our compound assignment
statement we are taking whatever value
we have in here which is a 45 we're
going to multiply that by 2 and the
result of that is going to be 90 and
we're going to store that back in value
here and if we print value here we're
going to get a 19. let's build this run
the gcc task and we're going to run our
program and we're going to see that
we're going to see this 90 here we can
go down by a few lines and put in the
code to play with a division version of
this
again this is going to do really the
same thing only it's going to be doing
this for division we're going to take
whatever value we have in here which is
going to be a 90 we're going to divide
that by 3 we're going to get a 30 and
that 30 results is going to be stored
back in value here and if we print this
out that's what we're going to get
let's build again and the build is going
to go through if we run
our program we're going to get a 30. we
are going to go down by a few lines and
put in a modulus version of this we're
going to grab whatever value we have and
this variable here which is going to be
30 we're going to do modulus 11 on that
value
and that's going to be basically 30
modulus 11. the result of that is going
to be 8
and we're going to store that result in
value here and if we print that out
that's what we're going to see in this
output statement here we can build again
run with gcc and if we run our rooster
program we're going to get an 8 printed
out and this is really all
these compound assignments are about and
you might be asking
why go through the trouble to do
something like this if i can do this
like this well c plus plus gives you
different way to do things different
people have different preferences and
some people me included like to do
things this way because it is compact
and once you use this you're going to
get used to this you're not even going
to think about it in this lecture here i
just wanted you to be aware of this
possibility because you are definitely
going to see it in c plus plus code out
there
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you found it
interesting we are going to stop here in
this lecture in the next one we're going
to learn about relational operators in c
plus plus in this lecture we're going to
learn about relational operators in c
plus plus and these are basically
operators you use to compare stuff let's
look at a piece of code here we have two
numbers one is 45 and another is 60 they
are stored in integer variables number
one and number two
we can print them out and we're going to
see them on the console or our terminal
and if we go down we can really compare
them we can use the less than operator
less than or equal operator
greater than greater or equal operator
we can check and see if two numbers are
equal by using two equal signs here be
careful about these two equal signs
because if you use one you're not going
to be comparing numbers you're going to
be taking the thing on the right and
assigning that to the thing on the left
so if you want to compare you're going
to have to type two equal signs another
operator we can use to compare stuff is
exclamation mark and equal which is
going to basically test if two numbers
are equal
and we're going to get the result one
thing you should notice here is that we
are wrapping our comparison expression
into parenthesis that's because if we
don't we're going to get a weird
compiler error that i am going to show
you when we get in visual studio code
but we don't have enough tools to really
understand this error
at this moment so what we are going to
do is avoid that problem by putting
parenthesis around our comparison
expression here we're going to go to
visual studio code and actually see this
in action here we are in our working
directory we're going to grab the code
from our template here and we're going
to put that in the current project which
is
relational operators we're going to go
in and put in our code and we are going
to open this up in visual studio code
we're going to get rid of things we
don't need here we are going to put in
our code so that we can explore these
things we have two variables in one we
have a 45 in another we have a 60 and
these are integers the name for these
variables are number one and number two
we're going to print them out and we're
going to see them on the console now we
are going to compare them
one thing i haven't told you yet is that
these comparison operators evaluate to
booleans in other words they are going
to return true all false if you look
down here
we want to know if number one is less
than number two and the result of that
is whether that's true or false and this
really makes sense
so because of that we are using std bull
alpha here to force sddc out to print
this boolean value here as a true or
false instead of a one or a zero and we
have seen this before so if we try to
build this and run this let's bring up a
terminal we can use
and we're going to run the test to build
with gcc if we go down here and run our
rooster program we're going to get our
two numbers 45 and six and we want to
know if number one is less than number
two and that's true 45 is less than 60
so the result of this expression is
going to be true now you know how to use
this operator one thing i want you to
see is what could happen
if you
didn't use this parenthesis around this
expression here let's try this out we're
going to remove this parenthesis and
we're going to try and world we're going
to run the task to world with gcc and
we're going to get a really weird error
because
the compiler is going to try and
evaluate this operator first if we go
back to our c plus plus operator
precedence table
and look at the operators we are trying
to use in the sddc out statement we're
going to see that the
operator to print fans on the console
has high precedence than our comparison
operators here so the precedence for our
operator to print things to sdd out is
11 so it is higher and the
precedence for our comparison operators
is nine and eight so the compiler is
going to try and do this operator first
if we come back in visual studio code
the compiler is going to try and think
that you are printing number one but
then again it's going to see this less
than sign and things are going to blow
up we don't really have enough tools to
understand what is going on right now
but i just don't want you to see this
arrow and show you a way to go around it
and move on with your life by comparing
stuff in your c plus plus programs if
you put parentheses around here the
problem is going to go away let's try
and build again
we're going to build with gcc
and everything is going to go back to
normal and we're going to see our output
if we run our rooster program here
this is how you can do this okay now
that we have a basic understanding of
this we can try the other operators and
it is going to be a walk in the park we
are going to go down here and put in our
remaining operators we can use less or
eco operator to test and see if number
one is less or equal to number two we
can use the greater than operator to
test and see if number one is greater
than number two we can use the greater
or equal operator
we can use the equal equal operator to
test that number one is equal to number
two and we can use this operator here
which is made up of the exclamation mark
and an equal sign to test and see
if two numbers are not equal
and all these operators are going to
evaluate to a boolean
basically saying if what you are testing
for is true or false and we can print
this out and notice that we have this
parenthesis around to avoid the problem
i just showed you a few minutes earlier
and if we run this we're going to see
the results
let's weld this with gcc as usual
we're going to run our program and
you're going to see that number one is
less than number two this is true
number one less or equal to number two
this is also true
number one greater than a number two 45
is not greater than 60 so this is false
it's not greater than equal so this is
also false
number one equals to number two this is
going to be false and uh the last
statement that is going to test and see
if number one is not equal to number two
is going to evaluate to true because
number one is not equal to number two if
this is not making sense yet please go
through it a couple of times and if you
have a problem please do ask me i will
do the best i can to help you out
another thing i want you to see before i
let you go
is that you can store the results of
these operators into a variable and use
that later in your program for example
here we can take our expression to
compare
number one and number two the result of
that is going to be installed in this
bold variable
and we can print it out later
like this
if we run this
we're going to build with gcc and we're
going to run the program
we're going to see that 45 equals to 60
is false and it is coming from this
statement here you can try and change
these numbers for example change this to
a 20 and see the results that we get and
you can try and run these in your mind
and see that they really make sense if
we run rooster now we're going to get to
different results because we are now
comparing 45 and 20 and here at the last
statement you see that they are not
equal if we put into equal numbers we're
going to get a true there let's try this
out we're going to run the task to build
with gcc and if we clear so that we get
rid of all this noise and run rooster
we're going to get
20 is equal to 20 and this is true this
is really all we set out to do in this
lecture i hope you have a better idea of
these relational operators in z plus
plus
we're going to stop here in this lecture
in the next lecture we're going to learn
about logical operators in c plus plus
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about logical operators these
operators will work on boolean operands
we're going to look at end first to
really make sense of how they work here
is a simple table we can use to try out
the end operation it is going to be
working on two operands a and b
and in the third column here we're going
to have the result so if a is false and
b is false and we do a and b
the result is going to be false if a is
false and b is true the result is going
to be false if a is true and b is false
the result is going to be false if a is
true and b is true the result is going
to be true the way you can think about
this and operator is that
if any of the operands is false the
result is going to be false and if you
really use this way of understanding
this it is going to be really easy and
the first line here we have a false so
the result is going to be false and the
second line we have a force it's going
to be force in the third line we have a
false the result is going to be false
but in the line number four here we
don't have a false a is true and b is
true so the result is going to be true
another operator we have is or
and it is going to evaluate to true
if any of the operands is true let's
look at the first line here a is false
and b is false so we don't have a true
the result is going to be false on the
second line we have a true the research
is going to be true on the third line we
have a true the research is going to be
true on line number four we have a true
the result is going to be true and you
don't really have to memorize these
tables if you use these operators long
enough these things are going to be
drilled in your memory if you have any
problem with these operators just look
up tables like this and you can find
whatever it is you need without really
memorizing these things another operator
is the not operator which is going to
negate whatever you give it so if a is
true and we negate that we're going to
get a false if a is false and when you
get to that we're going to get it true
and we use this exfoliation mark to say
that we are negating something if you go
back to or it is denoted by these two
vertical bars and the end operator is
denoted by these two ampersand
symbols here okay now that we know about
these logical tables for these logical
operators we can actually try to use
them in code
here we have three boolean variables we
have a b c
a is true b is false c is true we can
print them out and you see that we are
setting up sddc out to give us the
results in the format of true and false
instead of ones and zeros
and down here you see that we are trying
to use the and logical operator
down here you have a and b a and c and
we are doing this on three operators and
chaining these things up so we are
saying a and b and c and let's try and
do this in our mind to see that we
really understand this we have seen that
the end operator evaluates to true
when all operands are true another way
to say this is the end operator
evaluates to false if any of the
operands is false so we're going to end
a and b a is true b is false so the
result is going to be false because we
have a false in here a and c is going to
evaluate to true because a and c are
true a and b and c is going to evaluate
to false because we have a false in here
even if you have 1 000 tools and you end
that with one false that's going to be
dragged down to evaluate to false that's
what we are seeing here we can also do
all operations on these things and
this is going to give you a true if any
of the operands
is true we know that a is true and b is
false so this is going to evaluate to
true a and c is also going to evaluate
to true because a is true
a and b and c is going to evaluate the
true because a is true
so let's go back and see this these are
the values we're going to be using here
we can also try out the nut operator and
it is going to negate whatever we gave
it so if a is true we're going to get a
false b is false we're going to get it
true c is true we're going to get a
false another thing you can do is
combine this logical operators so we can
do something like a and b and all of
that with a c
and you should notice that we are
wrapping our expressions here in
parenthesis so that we don't have the
same problem we experienced and
explained in the last lecture and one
thing you should know is that for the
compiler to evaluate these things we are
going to follow the rules in our table
for precedence and associativity but we
used parentheses to really make this
easy to follow so we are going to end a
and b
and the result of that is going to be
ored with c and you can try and do this
in your mind and you're going to figure
this out but we're also going to go to
visual studio code in a minute and we're
going to see all these things in action
the last thing you can do is combine
logical and relational operators into
expressions for example here we have d e
and f they are integers and we can print
them out like we are doing here but we
can do something like
d greater than e
and we're going to end the result of
that with d greater than f
and we know that these relational
operators evaluate to booleans so we can
use these booleans with logical
operators like we have been doing all
along in this lecture so for example
let's evaluate the first one here in
mind so that you really see what this is
all about
d is 45 e is 20 so d greater than e is
going to evaluate to true
d greater than f
that's also going to evaluate to true so
true and true
that's going to evaluate to true and
this should print a true
on the terminal
we are going to go to visual studio code
and actually play with this thanks
okay here we are in our working
directory we're going to jump into our
template project and copy the files we
need and we're going to put them in our
lecture on logical operators we're going
to put that in here
we're going to open up this folder in
visual studio code and it is going to
show up here in visual studio code we're
going to get rid of what we don't need
and we are going to put in the code to
play with these things we have three
boolean variables a is true b is false c
is true
and we can print them out and we're
going to see their values and you see
the setup here so that sddc out is going
to show thanks in the format of true and
false and down here we are ending a few
values we are using the and operator and
it is denoted by these two ampersand
signs
so
a is true and b is false and c is true
a and b is going to evaluate
to false because we have a false in here
and again if this doesn't make sense
please do consult the tables for all
these logical operators and all these
things are going to make sense this is
going to evaluate to false because we
have a false in here and a and c we have
true and true so this is going to
evaluate to true and
a and b and c this is going to evaluate
to false because we have a false in here
remember as soon as you have a false in
your and logical operation you're going
to get a false in your result so we're
going to have a false here we can try
and compile this and see if this is
actually what we expect we're going to
bring up a terminal we're going to use
here and we're going to run the tasks to
build with gcc
and if we run our rooster program we're
going to see that a and b is false
this is what we expect
a and c is true this is what we expect
a and b and c
is false and this is what we expect
this is how you can really play with
your and logical operator if you want
you can change things up to really
try and see if they live up to your
expectations
now we have changed a to false let's try
and build again we build with gcc
and we're going to run our program
and we're going to get a and b is false
because they are all false a and b are
false so false and false evaluates to
false
a and c is false because a is false so
we're going to get a false as the result
a and b and c is also going to evaluate
to false okay we have this tension here
let's bring this back to what it was
before so a is going to be true b is
going to be false c is going to be true
and we're going to try and play with the
or operator we are going to go down and
put in code to actually play with this
and it is really nothing special we are
just using the or operator here which is
denoted by these two vertical
symbols and or is going to evaluate to
true
when at least one of the operands is
true okay so we have our values here a
is true b is false c is true a or b is
going to evaluate to true because a is
true
a or c is going to evaluate to true
because a is true
a or b or c is going to evaluate to true
because one of these things is true and
a is true here
we can try and run this we're going to
build this first
with gcc and if we run this
we're going to go down here and run
rooster again
and you're going to see that all these
things are true here because one of
these things is shown and as long as you
have one true operand your or operation
is going to evaluate to true and again
this is following the precedence and
associativity rules we have if we go
back to our table in our browser we're
going to try and look at logical or
it is
left associative so we're going to try
and evaluate this from left to right so
we're going to or a and b and the result
of this is going to be ord with c we
have also seen the not operator which is
denoted by the exclamation mark here and
what it is going to do is basically
flip off or negate whatever it is you
have if you have it true in your
variable the result is going to be false
if you have uniforms the result is going
to be true
and not a is going to be false because a
is true not b is going to be true
because b
is false and not c
is going to be false because c is true
as we can see here so let's run the
application and see if this is what we
expect
we're going to run and build with gcc
and we're going to run rooster and we're
going to see that note a is false not b
is true and not c is false and this is
what we expect we have also seen that we
can do combinations of these operators
so for example we can look at the
expression we have here
we're going to
take a and b this is going to evaluate
to false because b is false
we're going to negate this and we're
going to get a true and we're going to
order that with c
but because it's true
we know that the result of ordering this
with anything is going to be true so we
expect this expression here to evaluate
to true if we run this
we're going to see that this is going to
evaluate to true and it is what we
expect
the last thing we want to see in this
lecture is that we can combine
these logical operators with the
relational operators we have seen in the
last lecture we are going to put in a
piece of code to play with this this is
lengthy but you can play with this and
see what this is going to evaluate to to
start you off we are going to do the
first one together so it does test if d
is greater than e and if you look here
45 is greater than 20 so this is going
to evaluate to true
and we're going to enter that with d
greater than f
the result of this is going to be true
so we're going to be ending a true and a
true and the result of this is going to
be a true and again you notice that we
are wrapping this in parenthesis to
avoid problems
with the compiler being confused with
what we are trying to print this is
going to get rid of the otherwise ugly
problems we might have to deal with if
we didn't wrap this into parentheses
like this so we expect to see a true
here and we're going to weld
and run the task to build with gcc
and we're going to run rooster and if we
look at the first thing here this is
going to be true and you can try and do
the other ones in your mind as an
exercise and if you have a problem don't
hesitate to ask me i am going to do the
best i can to help you out
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you have a better
understanding of these logical operators
again you don't have to really memorize
them all you have to do is consult the
tables and you're going to basically
know the result of your two operands
depending on the values you have inside
for and or and the not operator we are
going to stop here in this lecture in
the next one we're going to see how we
can format our output to make it really
look better go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to look at output formatting and c
plus and this is the way we can format
stuff we send it to the terminal through
sddc out and make them show up better as
an example let's say we have a table
here that has names and ages
and you see that they are cramped and
through output formatting we can take
this and turn this into this
and hopefully we agree that this is
better
there are a set of tools we can use in c
plus plus and those we're going to be
using in this lecture are going to be
coming from these two libraries ios and
io manip and there are a lot of things
in these two libraries here is a a set
of cards that show a lot of them we are
going to play with a lot of these in
this lecture so you don't have to worry
if some of them seem scary
right now before we start looking at
them i want to bring to your attention
that there is a piece of documentation
on these things the link is here the
website is called
cppreference.com
and you can open this up and look at
some of the things we're going to talk
about in this lecture okay the first one
we're going to look at is stdendl
this is not new we have been using it
all day long to print out a new line
character so that our htdcl statements
print things on different lines and if
we don't have this manipulator you see
here on the top we have hello and world
and if we print them out they are going
to show up on one line because we are
not separating the lines with std e and
dl down below here we have another way
we can do this we can post a backslash n
after our text and that's going to add a
new line character just like std endl
does okay stdndl and slash n in here
seemingly do the same thing
but they are different but we don't have
enough tools to really understand the
differences right now for now just think
of them as two things that do the same
thing they print out a new character
that allows your text to show up on
different lines like we have hello and
world here okay stdndl is the first
manipulator we're going to play with in
this lecture the next one we're going to
look at is sdd flush
and this is going to send whatever is in
the output buffer to the terminal
and what the heck is an output buffer
let's look at an example suppose we have
sddc out here and we want to print on
this terminal and the message we want to
print is hello world how are you so what
is going to happen if the sddc out
statement is executed things are not
going to be directly sent to the
terminal they are going to go into an
intermediary buffer you can think of
this as some kind of storage in which
data goes before it goes to the terminal
and this is what's going to happen we
print out hello hello is not going to go
to the terminal directly
we print out world
it's not going to go to the terminal we
print out how are you
it's not going to go to the terminal and
when the buffer is full
the data is going to be sent to the
terminal in one go and this may come in
handy in some situations so if you want
the data to go to the terminal directly
you're going to add an sdd flash
after your hddc out statement and we are
going to play with this in a minute in
visual studio code and you're going to
see how this works another manipulator
we have which is really cool is set with
and it is std set w here and what it
does it specifies a width for whatever
text you want to print here we have two
examples the first one is our table that
is not formatted well and you see we
just print out the data and it is going
to show up like we see here on the right
we can use std set with to set the width
of the text here and for example the
last name here is going to show up in a
field which is 10 characters white this
is what we mean here and we do the same
for the first name and the age and if we
do this
data is going to show up nicely as we
see here and again i hope we agreed that
what we have down below here is much
better than what we had here
which was not formatted with set width
and this is how you use this manipulator
here we can also use what we call
justification to control whether our
data shows up on the right or on the
left
in the width that is allocated to it for
example here the
justification is sdd right so the data
is going to show up to the right in its
respective cells we can also use what we
call internal justification by which if
we are showing a negative number the
sign is going to be left justified so it
is going to show up on the left but the
data is going to be right justified and
this may come in handy if you want to
display some tabular data
in your terminal we can also use std set
field to specify the field character in
our empty spaces for example here we set
the dash as a field character and the
result is what you see down below here
we have seen std ball alpha and its
effect is to force
stdc out to show boolean output in the
form of true and false if you don't put
this manipulator in you're going to see
those pieces of data as ones and zeros
so for example here we have two
variables condition and other condition
if we print them out they are going to
show up as one and zero we are going to
set our manipulator here so the data is
going to show up as true and false we
can disable this manipulator here with
std noble alpha and the data is going to
go back to be shown in the form of one
and zero this is what this manipulator
does we also have one to show the
positive sign for positive numbers
so
if we don't enable it the data here is
going to show up like this 34 and minus
45 you see that the minus sign is going
to be shown regardless of the setting
you have for this manipulator but if we
enable std show pose
we're going to show the positive number
and this may make sense for whatever
application you might be doing
we can disable this with std no show
posts and after we do this the data is
going to show up in its default format
that we have seen before this is how you
use std show posts we also have
manipulators to control
the base in which the data is shown and
we can show the data either in a decimal
in octo or in hexodecimal if you look at
the data here we have an integer which
is positive we have an integer which is
negative and we have a double variable
here and we have some data n for us to
play with we're going to show our
positive integer in these three bases
decimal hex and octo
and the result is what you see here and
this should be no surprise you already
know
these number systems and how they work
we can take the negative number and also
show it in different bases decimal
hexadecimal and octo and it is what you
have on the right here in our terminal
if we go down and try to show
a double or a floating point number in
these bases the result is not going to
change because these number systems have
no effect on floating point numbers if
you remember we have seen that floating
point numbers
are represented in memory following
another protocol that is really advanced
for
a course like this so we are just going
to use this but we're not going to try
and understand it because it is out of
scope for what we are doing here we can
also use std show base
to show the base of our output
so here we have a positive number which
is an integer and we can show it in
decimal hex and act and we're going to
see what we see here to the right but we
can choose to also show the base of
whatever it is we output if we want to
specify that the output is in decimal
we're going to say that here but we can
also decide to show the base and we
enable that with std show base like this
and if we do this we're going to see
decimal is not going to have anything in
front hex is going to have a 0x in front
oct is going to have a zero in front and
by this it is going to be very easy to
see
the base in which your data is displayed
we can also use std upper case for the
data we print out to be shown in
uppercase where it makes sense for
example here we are trying to print
numbers in hexadecimal here in the
middle so if we don't use uppercase
which is the default
the number is going to show up like this
you see a and f are lowercase but if we
enable uppercase we're going to see this
in uppercase and sometimes this is going
to be helpful for whatever application
you are using the sun we also have a few
manipulators to control how floating
point data is shown on the terminal and
the two of these are std scientific and
sdd fixed by default stdc out is going
to show
in scientific format where necessary and
it is going to use fixed by default so
what we have here
we have three variables abc
and if we just print them out they are
going to show up in this format here if
we use fixed we're going to force the
output to be in fixed format and you're
going to see that the third number in c
here is going to show up as 0.0 and a
few zeros after that because in the
precision that we have now we can't
really show a number that is as low as
we have here in c again we have seen
this scientific format this is
basically 1.34
multiplied by 10 to the power of minus
10 and this is a really really low
number so we're going to do
0.000 up to 10 and that's when this
decimal point is going to show so it's a
number that is really close to zero
that's why we are showing it like 0.0
here i hope this makes sense we can also
use scientific notation if we want that
and if we force scientific notation
everything is going to be shown in
scientific notation another thing that i
really want you to be aware of is that
there is no official way to set
the
floating point output to its defaults
and here is a hack i actually learned
about when i was making this course the
explanation of this is really out of
scope for this course but just use this
to set
the floating point output format to the
defaults and if you do this you're going
to get whatever we had
here with the defaults you're going to
see that it is the same things the next
thing we're going to look at is std set
precision which we have seen before and
this is going to set the precision
with which the data is going to show up
on the terminal if you use a precision
of 10 that's what you're going to get
here here you see that we have a double
number it is a number that has a lot of
numbers after the decimal point if we
show it by default it's going to show up
like this the precision is going to be
sex we can increase the precision to 10
to 20 and 50 and it is going to show up
at whatever precision that you specify
here
please know that this precision is going
to be limited by the type of this a
variable
if it is a floating point the precision
is going to be something like 7 we have
seen that if it is a double the
precision is going to basically double
to something like 15 and if you have a
long double the precision is going to be
something bigger than double but it
can't go below that of a double we have
seen this before we also have show point
which is going to force
showing the decimal point for floating
point values you see here we have a 12.0
this is the most important piece of data
we have here
if we don't do show point this is going
to show up as 12 in the output here but
we can use show point to force for the
decimal point to be shown and you see
that
12.00 here is shown another side effect
of this is that
show point is going to force the showing
of trailing zeros and it is what we see
here in d e and f we have seen a lot of
manipulators here is a table that is
going to show where many of these are
going to be living so if you need to use
set width this is going to be living
in the i o manip header and here we have
a few other ones so if you want to use a
few of these things these are the
libraries that you will need to include
with pound include as we have been
including i o stream and again the
documentation for these things is shown
at
cppreference.com this is the exact link
and you can check this out if it helps
out
now that we have an idea about these
things we're going to go in visual
studio code and actually see these in
action okay here we are in visual studio
code the project we're going to be
working on here is output formatting so
we're going to be
grabbing
our template files
and put those in our project here
and we're going to go up again and open
up this folder in visual studio code
let's do that we're going to close the
welcome screen here and we're going to
remove whatever it is we don't need
we're going to take this out
and we are going to put in the first
code we want to play with and this is
stdendl
you don't really need a lot of
explanations for this because we've used
this all along
if you don't put it out the data is
going to show up on one line and uh
you're going to have hello world on one
line
if we put stdndl like this we're going
to have the data show up on different
lines so we're going to have hello and
world on different lines and it is
possible to use a backslash n to achieve
the same thing but these work very
differently underground and we don't
have enough tools to really understand
the difference so for now just take this
as the truth and i know that there are
differences and the most important thing
is that you recognize these things if
you see them in code out there we are
going to bring up our terminum and build
this with our task that is going to
build with gcc
you're going to see that the world is
going to go through
and that we can run our rooster
binary to see the output you see that we
have hello world on one line
we have hello and world on different
lines and this is a result of these
events we have here you see we have
stdndl this is going to force
the terminal to go to the next line and
print world and after that we're going
to force the terminal to go to the next
line and that's where the next text is
going to show up after that we have
hello and world down here in the
terminal and it is the output generated
by the statements that we have in here
and you can see that it is going to
basically do the same thing as stdendl
but again they work very differently
under the hood okay so this is really
how std endl works and you get access to
it by including the i o stream
library here the next thing we're going
to play with is std flash
this is going to flash the output buffer
to its final destination and that's
going to be
the terminal in this case and if we add
that to our
stdcl statement like this
this is going to be directly sent to the
terminal and this may come in handy in
some applications if we run this we're
not going to really see a difference but
underground under the hood the data is
directly sent to the terminal and we had
the chance to explain this in the slides
earlier we can work this program and i
see it running the world is going to go
through if we run the rooster we're
going to see that this is a nice message
is sent
to the terminal the next thing we're
going to look at is set with i am going
to put in the code here because i don't
want to type all this and again you can
get the source code for this
in the results section of this lecture
you don't really have to type all these
things the most important thing is that
you really understand how they work okay
you see here we are going to use set
with but we haven't really included the
library that is going to give us access
to this and if you don't know which
library you will need to include to get
access to this well you can check the
documentation and to get access to the
documentation you might want to consult
your favorite search engine i am going
to go in google here and type in std
set w and i am going to search and this
is going to come up with a few entries i
am going to click on the one from
cppreference.com because this is
reliable in my opinion and if we open
this up we're going to see that to work
with us you need to include i o my net
so this is what we need to put in visual
studio code to get rid of this problem
let's do that i really wanted you to see
this process you can go through
to know what you need to include we're
going to put this in and hopefully the
arrow is going to go away and we can
focus on studying the effects of these
things here this is going to print and
formatted so the data is going to be
cropped close to each other but we can
format this using set width and if we
pass in a 10 here we are basically
saying last name is going to take the
width of 10 characters even if we don't
really have 10 characters in this so so
you're going to have spaces fill the
remaining spaces so that the data shows
up nicely this is really hard to say in
world so i am going to run this in a
minute so that you can see this but
before we run i want you to see that you
can also store the width information in
a variable like this and i use that
instead in your std statements the
benefit with that is that it is really
easy to change this with if you happen
to change your mind otherwise you would
have to change a lot of things and this
is really bad design i did this to show
you how you can use this but in real
code you are most probably going to
store
your weft information in a variable and
that way it's going to be really easy to
change and update if you happen to need
that we can build this program with gcc
and if we run it let's bring this up a
little bit we're going to have our data
that is unformatted and you see that it
is really ugly but down below here we
have our formatted table and it is
really nice we have last name first name
and age and it is easier to see these
things we're going to see that it is
possible to
force the data to show on the left or to
the right with justification and we're
going to look at code that does that
next
if we go down here and put in the next
piece of code we want to play with we're
going to see that data is right
justified by default but we have seen
this also you see that gray is cramped
to the right of the width of the cell
for the first name so data is right
justified by default and it is the same
here
if we
change the width of our
data here and trying to run we're going
to have a better visualization of that
so let's run a little bit we're going to
build the world is going to go through
and if we run this we're going to see
that data is going to show up to the
right gray is to the right woods is to
the right and this is the default
justification you get
when you set with like this you can also
cause for the data to be left justified
and you do that by coming here and
changing this to left you can do that
but let's keep this in here instead
for your reference and let's put in
another piece of code to justify the
data to the left okay let's go down and
do that we're going to justify the data
to the left and if we print this out the
data here gray should come to the left
and be aligned with the first name here
i hope this makes sense we're going to
run we build with gcc and if we run
rooster gray is going to be justified to
the left this is the meaning of std left
and std right that we just saw and know
that data is justified to the right by
default and it is important to keep the
defaults in your mind
data is going to be justified to the
right by default the next thing we can
do is to make our data internal
justified and what this is going to do
is make the sign left justified and the
data is going to be right justified and
the best way to save this is really to
see an example
so here we have the data it's a negative
floating point number the width is set
to 10 it's going to be right justified
but we are also going to set the
justification to internal and see the
difference
let's weld and run this we're going to
world with gcc and we are going to run
our rooster program and if we look at
the output here you see that if we have
right justification
the sign is going to go with the data
whereas if we do internal justification
the sign is going to go to the left and
the data is going to go to the right and
sometimes this is useful depending on
the application that you are welded
especially in applications where you
have to display tabular data on the
console or of the terminal we can also
specify the field character using set
field
and this is really how it works the data
is going to be left justified but we are
going to fill empty
spaces with a dash here and we can bring
this up so that you see the entire thing
but you don't really have to type this
out you can use the code i have provided
in the resources section of this lecture
you can just copy it paste it in here
and use it to play with these things
okay with this our empty spaces are
going to be filled with this dash
character
let's world and build with gcc we are
going to run this and you're going to
see that we have a field character here
and you can change this basically to
whatever you want if i want i can change
this to a star let's do that and i can
build again if i run this it's going to
be filled with stars right now the next
thing we're going to look at is std bull
alpha we have seen this before but what
it's really going to do is force the
output to be in the format of true and
false
and the default is in the form of one
and zero here we have a few variables
and that they are of bull type
the first set of stdcl statements here
is going to print in the format of one
and zero we are going to set the output
to both alpha and it is going to be in
the format of true and false and then we
can disable the bull alpha with this
setting here which says hdd no pull
alpha we can vote this and see the
effect of this so we're going to run
rooster again and you're going to see
that condition 1 0 condition true false
condition 1 0 we are able to modify how
our boolean data is displayed on the
console using these two settings here
use them if they make sense for your
application the next thing we're going
to look at is show pose and we're going
to just put in the data
we have two numbers positive number
which is 34 a negative number which is
minus 45 and we can decide if we want to
show
the plus sign for positive numbers by
default the plus sign is going to be
hidden it's not going to be shown if you
want it shown you can use the show pose
manipulator and if you want to disable
that when it was enabled you can use no
show pose and this is going to do what
you want we can build this again and if
we look at the output we're going to see
that post num doesn't have a plus sign
in front because by default the show
pause is disabled and we set the setting
here and we're going to see the plus
sign and if we disable that we're not
going to see the plus sign again this is
the effect of std show posts and std
neutral pose manipulators we can also
affect the base in which the data is
displayed on the terminal and we do this
by setting the output base system
we can set std deck to force the output
in decimal
std hex to force the output to be in
hexadecimal and std act to force the
output in octal and this is only to take
effect for integral types this is not
going to have effect for floating point
numbers for example here we have a few
variables a positive integer and
negative integer and a floating point
number which is the double
and we're going to try and print these
things in all these base systems we're
going to
print these things in the default format
we're going to see how they look we are
going to take the positive number and
show that in these different number
systems we're going to do the same for
the negative number and we're going to
show that
this doesn't have effect on floating
point numbers because these number
systems don't really work for floating
points we can run this and see the
output we are going to run the task that
is going to build with gcc and we're
going to clear and run rooster and what
we're going to see is that by default
positive number is going to be this
negative number is going to be this and
our double var is going to be this and
we are going to take the positive number
show it in different base systems in
decimal it's going to be like this in
hex it's going to be like this in act
it's going to be like this the negative
number is also going to be
in this format here so if we show it in
decimal it's going to be like this hex
it's going to be like this and octo it's
going to be like this you can see that
the double var which is a floating point
is not really affected it's going to be
showing in the same format regardless of
the base that we set here one thing you
should know is that this base setting
here is going to stick so here for
example you see that we have set output
to octo
so any other thing that we're going to
print out is going to be shown in octo
and we have to be sure that's what we
want if that's not what we want we will
have to reset
the output
number system and it's going to take
effect this is how you can use these
things to affect
different number systems for output in
your terminal we have seen that you can
also force things to show up in
uppercase if that's important for your
application for example here we have a
positive number if we show that in hex
this is going to contain a few
characters
and if we don't set uppercase
it is going to show up in lowercase and
if we want it in uppercase we can set
this setting and it is going to show up
in uppercase this may be helpful in some
applications and i just want you to be
aware of these things we're going to
world and run our application
we're going to see that
let's bring this up a little bit so that
we have some breathing room our positive
integer here is going to show up in
lowercase here in hex because this is
going to contain characters and if we
set uppercase you're going to see that
the characters are going to show up in
uppercase and this is the effect of this
setting here we can also affect how
floating point data
is printed out on the terminal
for example here we have a few variables
a b and c
and by default they are going to show up
with decimal points and use scientific
notation where necessary but we can
choose to use
fixed for example if that's what we need
in our application and the output is
going to be shown using fixed notation
with decimal points if we want we can
force the scientific format and we do it
like this and all output is going to be
in scientific format and we can disable
all these settings and reset this to the
defaults
with this piece of command here there is
no official way to
set floating point output to the
defaults and this is a hack i actually
learned about when i was preparing the
code for this course and the proper
explanations for this are really out of
scope for this course so if you want to
reset the floating point output format
to the default you're going to use this
but we don't really have enough tools to
understand this yet so just take it by
faith and you're going to see that if we
run this it's going to work let's try
and run this through the compiler and
that the world is going to go through if
we run this and i bring this up a little
bit so that we have a little bit of
breathing room we're going to see that
our double values are a b and c and
that's what we have in our code here and
by default it's not going to be able to
show these things because of the
precision limits so we're going to have
3.14159
it's going to go up to here and the rest
is going to be chopped off if we use
fixed formats you're going to see that
whatever we had in scientific format
it's going to show up in fixed format
and again this is a really low number
that's why we have 0.000
here
we can force the output to be scientific
as we did
right here
and all output is going to be in
scientific format
down below here we use our hack to set
to
the defaults and you see that it's going
to go back to the initial format that we
had before this is how you use std fixed
and std scientific
to
manipulate how your floating point
numbers are printed to the terminal we
have also seen that we can set the
precision of our output in the terminal
here we have a variable a it is of type
double as you can see in a visual studio
code here if you hover over a variable
you're going to be able to see its type
we can choose to see this in whatever
precision we want 6 is the default in
our case here but we can choose to set
the precision to 10 20 or whatever it is
really we want
please note that this is going to be
limited by the precision that your type
supports so for example we know that a
double has a precision of 15 and if we
have more than 15 digits in here the
rest is going to be garbage just be
aware of that we're going to try and
build this and we're going to use gcc as
usual and if we run this
we're going to get our numbers in
different precisions the first one is
using the default which is going to be
6.
if we use 10 we're going to get 10
digits if we use 20 we're going to get
20 digits but if we go over the
precision that our type here supports
we're going to get garbage i hope this
makes sense the last thing we're going
to see is show point and we have seen
that
this is used to force
outputting the decimal point let's say
that here and a good example for that is
this 12 here
if we print it out
here we're not going to get the decimal
point by default it's going to print 12
but if we go down and force output of
the decimal point here we're going to
get something like 12.0
and another effect of this is that it's
going to add trailing zeros to fill
whatever space is allocated for your
output variable in the terminal
let's try and run this so that we can
actually see this running we're going to
run our rooster executable and in the
first group here we don't have the
setting for show point and if you look
at the numbers that we had in our code
the first number is 34.1 and you see
that we are padding a lot of numbers
because we had set our precision to a
really big number in the last example
that we have run let's actually go there
and show you that that's why we're
seeing the precision of 20
it is really huge but no big deal we can
reset this to whatever we want if this
is too much for us
the important thing here is that we have
34.1 and that's what we are seeing and
if you go to our 12 here you see we have
12.0 but our output is not showing
the decimal point here if it is
important to show the decimal point we
can do std show point here and it is
going to show up this is really what is
important in this piece of code here and
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture we had a chance to play
with a lot of these manipulators and the
best way to learn about these things is
really to try them out in code
and try to change a few things and see
how that affects the output you get in
the terminal and we had a chance to play
with many of these things in this
lecture there is a lot of these guys i
tried to make this lecture as extensive
as i can that's why it turned out to be
pretty long but once you've learned
about these fans and played with them in
code you're never going to forget them
one last point i want to emphasize again
is that the documentation is of utmost
importance it is really good to come
here and check things out for example if
we go to show point here we are going to
get a nice explanation of what this
manipulator does enables all disables
the unconditional inclusion of the
decimal point character and you can read
all this
and the nice thing is that if you go
down you're going to have a piece of
code
that you can use to really understand
whatever it is they are talking about
and this is priceless if you are
learning it is a good thing to be able
to use the documentation this is really
all we set out to do in this lecture it
turned out to be really long but i
really hope it was worth it for you
we're going to stop here in this lecture
in the next one we're going to learn
about numeric limits go ahead and finish
up here and meet me there in this
lecture we're going to be playing with a
few functions from this library
specifically we're going to be looking
at the minimum the maximum and the
lowest functions
and this is really how you use them you
can think of this t as a placeholder for
the type for which you want to know the
minimum the maximum and the lowest point
respectively i know this might be
cryptic to some of you so we're going to
look at a few specific examples here we
have a simple explanation of what these
functions mean
for floating point values
the minimum is going to represent the
smallest positive number
that is representable with that floating
point type the maximum is going to be
the maximum floating point number you
can represent and at the lowest number
is going to be the lowest negative
number you can represent with that type
things change a little bit when you
start dealing with integers and these
functions are going to look like this
the minimum is going to be the minimum
number you can represent with that
integer and lowest doesn't really mean
anything for integral types the maximum
is going to be the maximum number one
thing you have to keep in mind is that
the minimum may be negative
if you are using a signed integer if you
are using an unsigned integer for
example for short minimum is going to be
zero and the maximum is going to be the
maximum number representable with that
integer type here we are looking at
numbers for short and but the same story
applies to whatever integer type you are
using even if you happen to be using
long end or end without any modifier
remember that we had to do a lot of
things to get this range and it was
really hard to even do this for floating
point types so this library is helpful
in getting a sense of what we can
represent with the given type b8
floating point or integral let's head to
visual studio code and play with us here
we are in our working folder
we are going to copy code from our
template project
and we are going to go in the current
project which is numeric limits we're
going to go and put in our files
go up again and open this file up in
visual studio code we're going to close
this up open the main cpp file remove
whatever it is we don't need we are
going to include the limits library
remember this is the first thing we need
to do
if we want to play with these facilities
that we just looked at in the slides
and we are going to go down here and put
in the code we want to play with
and it is ridiculously simple
if you have watched the slides we just
did in a minute so what we're going to
be doing here we're going to be printing
out the range for each possible type we
want to play with here so we're going to
say the range for short and is from
and we're going to say std numeric
limits
short that's what we want to deal with
now and we're going to call the minimum
function this is going to give us
the minimum value we can represent with
short and we're going to say std numeric
limits and we're going to call the max
function
passing in the type for which we want to
get the range for
and the same story applies for
unsigned
short
you see that's the type we are using
here we are also going to play with ant
getting the range we're going to use
unsigned and
to see how these things behave we're
going to use long
and get to the range and we are also
going to be playing with floating point
types so we're going to compute the
range using the minimum function and the
maximum function and we are going to be
also using the lowest function to see
that this really is the same thing we
described in the slides we're going to
do this for double and long double and
see how these ranges
come up in this program what we're going
to do is open up a terminal here we are
going to run the task to build with gcc
and the build is going to be good
and we can go down and run rooster and
we're going to get our values here the
range for short and is from minus 32 768
up to 32
767 and you see that this is exactly the
same thing we saw in the lecture where
we talked about number systems we saw a
way you can do this manually by plugging
the
number of digits in some formula that we
came up you can go back and check that
out if you want we do the same for
unsigned short and and then we look at
floating point types we're going to
print the range for float
and if we use the
minimum function to get the start of the
range we're going to get the minimum
positive number we can represent with a
float if we use lowest we're going to
get the lowest minimum number and that
the maximum is going to be the same if
you think this is really small you have
the option to open up this folder in
file explorer and you can open a command
prompt or powershell window by hitting
shift and right clicking and choosing
this option here open powershell window
here
and you're going to get a bigger window
in which you can type things we're going
to run rooster and we're going to see
things in a much easier way here
this is an option you can use or you can
even use the integrated terminal inside
visual studio code here like we've been
doing all along there are a few other
facilities you can use in this library
of limits for example we can try and
print out if a number is signed or
unsigned or get the number of digits we
can represent in an integer type
these are a few examples i just chose
because they are easy to understand and
really helpful but you can find more
about this library
in the documentation
and if you come here at cppreference.com
the link is here you can really find all
about this library here this library
provides a standardized way to carry
various properties of arithmetic types
for example the largest possible value
of type and is this
and we have a bunch of things we can do
here don't be scared of by this template
thing
just think of them as placeholders for
the type for which you are trying to
query information for there are a few
functions you can call on these things
for example there is mean lowest max
that we just played with in visual
studio code but uh you can see that
there are a lot of things you can play
with especially if you have some math
background to understand all these
concepts here you can play with us and
see if it is helpful for whatever
application you are doing okay this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture to learn a little bit about the
limits library it is helpful in
trying to understand the ranges for your
types if you happen to need these kinds
of things this is going to come in handy
we're going to stop here in this lecture
in the next one we're going to learn
about some math functions we can use in
c plus plus go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to learn about math functions and
these are functions that are built into
the z plus plus standard library that we
can use to do some math if you are doing
some math operations you're going to
find this helpful
they live in the c math library and if
you want to use them you're just going
to include that and you're going to have
access to them what you see here is a
simple summary of some of the things you
can use in these math functions you can
use std flower to round down or hdd seal
to
round up you can use the abs function to
compute the absolute value of a number
you can do trigonometry you can do the
cosine sign and things like that you can
compute the exponential of a number
you're going to see what this means in a
few lectures you can use std log and
again if you have some math background
these concepts are not going to be
foreign to you many of these functions
are documented here at cpp reference so
it might be worthwhile to go there and
check what functions are available there
here is an example of something you
might want to do for example you have a
variable it's called weight inside we
have a 7.7 and if you do std floor of
this variable this is going to be
rounded down to a 7. if you want to
round up you're going to use std seal
and you're going to get that and we're
going to see what this is going to give
us in a minute when we hit visual studio
code here is how you would use the
absolute value function you have a few
variables here and if you try to plug
them in this absolute value function
you're basically going to get the weight
of the number without any sign in front
of the number positive or negative the
absolute value is the weight of the
number without caring about the sign if
i may say it like that okay we also have
the x function which is going to compute
the exponential of a number this is a
math concept so if you don't have a
background in math this is going to be a
little hard to wrap your brains around
but in math we have this number which is
called e
and its value is approximately 2.7 18 28
like you see here the exponential
function is going to do what f x here is
doing it's going to take e and elevate
that to the power of x and for example
in our code here we're going to get the
exponential of 10 which is going to be e
elevated to the power of tan and we're
going to play with this in visual studio
code and you're going to see the value
of this we also have the power function
here which is going to take the first
parameter and elevate that to the power
of the second parameter
so
this is going to be 3 to the power of 4
and 9 to the power of 3 and we're going
to get the answer if we plug this into
visual studio code and we have look
functions which is basically the reverse
of the power function that we just
looked at
if you do log 8 in base 2 for example
it is like you are asking to which power
should i elevate 2
so that i get 8.
and the answer here is going to be a 3
of course but the catch is that the log
function by default works in base e
so what we are asking for example if we
say log 54.59
is to which power should we elevate e
to get this number in here and it is
going to be computed and you're going to
see this if you plug this into
visual studio code or you can try to use
one of the calculators available to you
and you're going to see that this makes
sense we also have a special function
that is going to do the same thing but
in base 10
and this is going to be easier to
understand for example here we are
computing log 10
so
what we are really saying is to which
power should we elevate 10
to get 10 000 and this is easy because
the answer is a 4 10 to the power of 4
is 10 000 i really hope this makes sense
we also have a square route function we
can use so square out of 81 is going to
be nine
we have a function called std round
which can round
and uh what it's going to do by default
halfway points are going to be rounded
away from zero so if you have a 2.5 it's
going to be rounded up to a 3 and if you
have 2.4 it's going to be rounded down
to a 2. we also have a host of functions
we can use in trigonometry we have a
sine function we have a cosine function
we have a tan function if you know these
concepts in math this is going to come
in really handy if you want to do this i
have to say that what we just talked
about is a small set of what we can do
with these functions here in c math and
uh we are here at cppreference.com
and we can see all these functions here
we can do reminder we can do f men and
if you want you can check this out in
the documentation for example if you go
to can here and click on it you are
going to get the description and
explanation of what this function does
and you're going to have a simple
example of how you can play with us okay
now i hope you have a better idea of
what we can do with these functions in
the cmat library we're going to head to
visual studio code
and play with some of these functions
here we are in visual studio code the
current project we're going to work on
is math functions we're going to copy
over our template files
and we're going to put them in our
directory here math functions
and we are going to open this up in
visual studio code and we are going to
remove whatever it is we don't need
and we are going to include our library
which is c math
and we are going to put in our code so
that we can play with us
and here we have a variable called
weight
and we're going to try and use a few
math functions on it so we can use sdd
floor to round down
and std seal to round up so weighted
rounded to floor is going to be printed
out and way to round it to seal is going
to be printed out
we're going to have a number here
in this savings variable it's going to
be a negative number and we're going to
try and compute the absolute value of
this we're going to see it printed out
another thing we're going to
compute is the exponential of the value
we're going to do stdx 10
and what this is going to do is going to
take e
and raise it to the power of 10 and
that's what we're going to get printed
here the other thing we want to do here
is compute the power of a number we're
going to take 3 and raise it to the
power of 4 and take 9 and raise it to
the power of 3 and we're going to see
what these things evaluate to we're
going to open up our terminal here and
we're going to run the task to build
with gcc the world is going to be good
and if we run rooster we're going to get
these things here so 7.7 rounded to
floor is going to be seven so we're
going to round down 7.7 rounded to sale
is going to be eight and that's what
we're going to get and the absolute
value of weight is going to be
7.7 because it is a positive number and
the absolute value of minus 5000 is
going to be 5 000. and again when you
compute the absolute value of something
you are interested in the weight of that
thing without considering the sign
without really worrying if it is
positive or negative you just want to
get the magnitude of a number that's
what we use in math to mean that
magnitude okay so if we go down we're
going to get the exponential of 10 is
exponential
and you're going to get that here and
again what this function does is take e
and raise it to the power of 10
and that's the answer here we can try
and prove this with a calculator so i am
going to open my windows calculator you
can use whatever calculator you have
access to
i am going to use a scientific
calculator here and you see that we can
hit e and we're going to get the value
of this e number in math here it is
simplified but if i take it and raise it
to the power of 10 the answer is going
to be 22.026
and if we look in our program we have 22
26.5 okay it is rounded up a little bit
but it is almost the same thing okay we
also want to play with log functions a
little bit
log is basically the reverse of the
power function
and we just talked about this in the
slides
but
if we do log 18 base 2 we are basically
asking to which power should we raise 2
to get an 8
and the answer to that is going to be
what this log
number in base number is going to
evaluate to the catch is that the log
function if you use it row like this it
is going to be using base e and we just
saw that e is 2 to the power of 7 or
something let's go back to our
calculator and see if we can see that
why not why try to guess when we have a
good calculator in our hands we are
using the scientific calculator so if we
hit e here
this is the value of e
okay so
when we do log
we are basically asking to which power
should we raise e
so that we can get this
54.59 and the answer is going to be
computed and printed out here
we have a version of this that is going
to use base 10 so if we use this
we are basically saying to which power
should we raise 10 to get 10 000 and the
answer is going to be printed out here
and it is going to be a four because
this is easy to do in your mind so let's
run this we're going to build the task
we are going to run the task to build
with gcc and we're going to run our
program and uh we're going to get our
output here to get
54.59 you would elevate e to the power
of this number here this is the answer
and if you want you can prove this with
your favorite calculator you're going to
get something close to this to get 10
000 you'd need to elevate 10 to the
power of 4. that's what we're going to
get in here let's print this out again
many mistakes sorry but i hope you get
the point if we build again so that we
can see things properly and run we're
going to get proper data and this is
really what we expected to get we have a
few more functions we can play with as
we saw in our slides
let's play with square root and the std
round function here we are going to get
the square root of 81 we're going to get
it printed down and we're going to see
what std round does it is going to
round away from zero if we are at half
point and if we are not at half point if
we are below that we're going to round
down if we are higher than that we're
going to round up we're going to run
this so that you can see this running
and we're going to call rooster and the
2.5 is rounded to 3. 2.4 is rounded to
2. 3.6 is rounded to 4. this is what we
expect and the square root of 81
is 9. this is really all we set out to
do in this lecture to play with a few of
these c math function
they are not really hard to use once you
have the basics of math nailed down and
again if you want to check the full list
of these functions please come to our
reference documentation here you're
going to find a lot of them
and if you want to see how to use one of
these for example if you click on log 10
here you're going to come here you're
going to get an explanation of the
function and even better you're going to
go down and get a nice piece of code you
can play with and really make sense of
what is happening in these functions
here this is really all we set out to do
in this lecture i hope you found it
interesting we are going to stop here in
this lecture the next one we're going to
learn about some weird integral types
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about some weird integral types
and what do i mean by this well if you
look here integral types less than 4
bytes in size don't support arithmetic
operations and these are operations like
addition subtraction multiplication
division you can do these operations on
those types
and here i have an example of some of
those types we have a car it is one byte
in size and short end
is two bytes in size on most processors
so you can't do arithmetic operations if
your integer value is stored in these
types
why is that well this has to do with
processor design
and they decided to choose and as the
smallest type
integral type for which they can do
these arithmetic operations but
compilers are really smart enough to
notice if you are trying to do
arithmetic operations on these types and
they are going to implicitly convert
from
these smaller types to end
and this is something you need to be
aware of if we look at this program here
for example we have var1 and var2 they
are stored in variables that are of type
short and
and we have var 3 var 4 which are stored
in a variable of type car we can try and
print the resizes and we're going to get
two two one one for these variables
because a short end
occupies two bytes in memory for my
computer here and the car occupies one
byte in memory but the catch is down
here
if you try to add them up
the result is not going to be the same
type as defense you added up and you
would expect
auto
to deduce to the same type as var one
and var2
and it's not resort is going to be an
integer because and is the smallest type
for which we can support these
arithmetic operations so if we print the
size of result one and reserved two
we're going to get four but this is the
behavior you're going to get and we need
to be aware of it the same behavior can
be observed on other operators that we
will have a chance to look at in a few
chapters ahead and these are called
shift operators you use them to shift
bets but i don't want to talk anymore
about them because we're going to have a
chance to learn about them in detail
okay now is time to head to visual
studio code and actually see this in
action here we are in our working
directory we are going to copy our
template project we're going to copy
this
quickly put that in our folder on weird
integral types this is our current
project here and we're going to open
this up in visual studio code we're
going to open this up and we're going to
open our main cpp file remove whatever
it is we don't need and we are going to
put in our code this must be very
familiar because it is what we just saw
in the slides
so what we are doing here we have four
variables var one and var two are short
and so these are going to take two bytes
in memory on my computer here and uh car
is going to take up one byte and we're
going to print their sizes we're going
to see them printed down and we are
adding things up here we are taking two
short end variables and adding them up
so what the compiler is going to do it's
going to take this turn it into an end
and then do addition and the result is
going to be an end the same story is
going to happen for reserved 2 here
var 3 is a car so it is one byte in
memory but the compiler can't really add
up integral types which are smaller than
four bytes in memory so what is going to
happen var three is going to be
transformed implicitly behind the scenes
to a net and var four is going to be
transformed to a net and then we're
going to add that up and we're going to
store that in a neat variable which is
resort here
if we print this up we're going to see
that size of result 1 and result 2 is a
4 and this is what we expect here and
this is a behavior you need to be aware
of because sometimes your application
logic is going to depend on the size of
data if that's the case you need to care
about this
and if you don't know this you're going
to be beaten by this and it is really
hard to find problems like this
so what we can do is open up our
terminal and we're going to build this
with gcc as we usually do and that we
can run our program rooster and we're
going to see that this is what we expect
var1 is two bytes in size var2 is two
bytes in size wire three and waterfall
are one byte in size but our result is
four bytes because the compiler
implicitly converted
our operands here to x to be able to
carry out this arithmetic operation this
is really all we setup to do in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this
lecture the next one we're going to try
and recap what we saw in the chapter
congratulations on hitting the end of
this chapter and this chapter was really
about
doing operations and manipulating the
data that you have stored in your
variables the first thing we saw was
that we could do arithmetic operations
on the data we can add things up
multiply divide we also saw the modulus
operator which may seem weird for
beginners but we had a chance to really
play with us after that we learned about
precedence and associativity we saw that
that's a set of rules
we have to follow to know which
operation to do first if we have
multiple operators in our expression we
also had a chance to learn about prefix
and postfix increment and decrement
operators we had a chance to do compound
assignments things like plus equal minus
equal multiply equal modulus equal now
these things must be making sense to you
we had a chance to look at how we could
compare things using relational
operators like greater than lesser than
and equal or not equal we also had a
chance to look at output formatting and
we saw a host of things we could do to
make data show up better with sddc out
after that we learned about numeric
limits and this is a cool way to know
the ranges for your data types but there
are a host of other properties you can
use in this limits library we learned a
little bit about math functions and we
played with things like the power of
something the exponential the few
rounding functions that we have in the
cmat library and now you must have a
good idea about these functions that you
can use to manipulate and do math on
your variables we ended the chapter by
looking at some weird integral types and
the main message in that lecture was
that you can't do arithmetic operations
on data types whose size is less than 4
bytes in memory if you try to do that
the compiler is going to insert
implicit conversions and if your
application depends on the size of
things
this is something you need to be careful
about otherwise you're going to have a
hard time
finding these problems i would like to
welcome you in this new chapter where
we're going to be learning about a new
way we can do things in c plus plus and
we're going to be doing conditional
programming in other words we're going
to be able to do different things
based on the conditions that we have set
up in our code just to give you an
example here we have a few variables
they are booleans and we have a few
initializers in there red is false green
is true yellow is false police stop is
true and we can do
different things based on discipline
conditions for example
if the light is red we may be
told to stop
if the light is yellow we might be told
to slow down if the light is green we
might be told to go and do whatever it
is we want to do so we're going to be
able to do these kinds of things and c
plus plus provides different constructs
to be able to do conditional programming
in uc
code we just have one of them in this
slide which is this if statement here
this if keyword allows you to do things
like this we have a few others we have
the else keyword we have the switch
keyword we also have a completely
separate operator that is called ternary
operator that allows you to do these
kinds of things and we're going to be
learning about all these things and more
in this chapter we are going to start
and learn about the if statement in the
next lecture
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about the if statement and this is a
statement that is going to allow you to
do things based on some condition being
true
or false here is a simple code example
we have two variables number one and
number two
and we have a statement here that is
going to compare number one and number
two and we're going to store the result
in this boolean variable
that we have on the left then we're
going to do something based on the value
that we are storing in this result here
if the result in there is true we're
going to print
number one is less than number two if
the result is not true we're going to
say number one is not less than
number two and notice in the first if
close year we are testing for the case
where the result is true but sometimes
we need to do something when this
condition here is not true one way to do
that is to negate what we have here
inside the if parenthesis and test for
the reverse of whatever we have in here
if that is making any sense if you look
here we are testing for the case where
if not the result is a true and in other
words we are testing for the case where
the result here is false and we're going
to say number one is not less than
number two this is one way we can go
about this again the if statement is
used to do conditional programming this
is the syntax we use to do it in c plus
plus we say f we put a set of
parentheses and inside the parenthesis
we put the condition we want to test for
and after that we're going to have a
pair of curly braces and what we have
inside these curly braces is going to be
the body of our if statement and it is
basically going to be the code we want
to run if the test here is successful we
can also use an else clause to catch the
case where the test hasn't been
successful in this case we can say if
result equals true we're going to do
something
and else we're going to do something
else in other words if research is true
we're going to say is less than if it's
not true we're going to say is not less
than and this is a more compact way of
doing what we just did in the slide here
you can also directly use your
expression as a condition and the
requirement here is that the expression
evaluates to something that we can treat
like a boolean because the condition has
to be a boolean it has to be true or
false okay here is another simple
example we have seen this in the last
lecture we have a few variables
containing our conditions and we are
saying if the light is red for example
we're going to do something if it's
yellow we're going to do something if
it's green we're going to do something
we can also nest conditions for example
we can put our outer
if statement and inside that if
statement set up other if statements and
if our logic needs something like this
you can do this and you can take
advantage of this to achieve whatever it
is you want to do in this case if the
light is green we're going to
fall in here and we're going to do
another condition so if the light is
green and if the police officer has
stopped you you're going to stop and if
they haven't stopped you you're going to
go because the light is green and you
can do something like this
we can also use logical operators to
kind of achieve the same thing and we
say if the light is green and the police
officer hasn't stopped you you're going
to go else you're going to stop and you
can do something like this and you see
that you can combine the logical
operators we've learned about with the
conditional programming techniques we
are learning about here to do really
powerful stuff and we're going to be
doing this all over the place in the
course so we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with us here
we are in our working directory we're
going to be working on if statements and
we're going to grab our template project
the template files i should say and
we're going to put them in here
and we're going to open this up in
visual studio code as we always do so
let's do that open folder and we should
fall in here and open our main cpp file
let's do the usual and remove what we
don't need
and we are going to put in our code so
that we can really play with us we have
two variables in here number one and
number two they are integers and we have
the values 55 and 60 inside we can do a
comparison between these two variables
and what this comparison is going to
yield is a boolean value that we're
going to store in our boolean variable
here which is called result
and what we can do is use this to do
some conditional programming so we're
going to say if the result is true we're
going to do something and if the result
is not true we're going to do something
else and this is how we say it this
syntax here may be confusing to new
students but try to think of it if not
research is true and that's really the
same thing as saying if result is false
try to stream this in your mind a little
bit and you really are going to
understand okay so now that you have
seen this piece of code
try to
guess what we're going to see if we run
this what are we going to see on the
console okay give it a try so we're
going to run this in visual studio code
let's open up a terminal first
and we're going to world with gcc as we
always do
we're going to bring this up a little
bit so that we have some breathing room
and we're going to run rooster let's see
what we have here we have reserved
equals true and that's coming from this
statement here
and we have freestanding if statement
which is coming from
here and we have our meat of this
program what we really are interested in
we have 55 is less than 60. so our test
here succeeded and we fell in this body
and executed this sddc out statement
that's why we're saying number one is
less than
number two and number one is 55 which is
what we see here and number two is 60
which is what we are seeing here
so what can we do to make
the second statement here execute you
know it is testing for the case where
not result is true so it's going to
exactly do the reverse of what this test
here is doing
and if this fails this one is going to
succeed which is what we have now so
what we can do to really play with this
we can go up and change for example
number one to 65
this is going to flip the order of these
numbers if i may say it like that and if
we run it we're going to build with gcc
and run this
we're going to see result is false so
result became false because number one
is not less than number two so this is
going to be false and the test here is
going to fail result is not true so
we're not going to go in here and look
at here if not result is true so
research is true is false
if we negate this this is going to
become true and this test here is going
to succeed and we are going to fall in
here take some time to really understand
this and if you have a problem ask me i
am going to do the best i can to help
you out but make sure you understand
this because this is really fundamental
in your journey as a software developer
not just in c plus plus any career as a
software developer you're going to need
to understand this okay what we're going
to do is comment out
what we just did here because we're
going to see another way to do this and
we don't want to have noise output in
our terminal this is going to just make
things hard for us to see so what we're
going to do
we're going to go down in here and put
in another piece of code and
the result was commented out we don't
want to comment that out so we're going
to take this out because this is our
condition we're going to grab it and put
that outside our comment section this is
going to do and if we go down again
we're going to click on this file icon
and uh give ourselves some more
breathing room here we don't really need
to see that main cpp file anyway
so if we come here we can use the else
clause
to test for the case where our condition
fails
and if you look here we are essentially
saying the same thing we are saying if
result equals true we're going to fall
in here and else we're going to fall in
here so we don't need to do the double
if statements that we just did
here and this is much more compact and
easy to read let's look again at the
numbers we have here number one is 65
number 2 is 60. this expression here is
going to be false because 65 is not less
than 60 we're going to have a false in
here and if we come down
result is going to be false this is
going to fail and we are going to fall
down here we're going to say
number one
or 65 is not less than 60 which is what
we have in our values so we're going to
build this again and we're going to run
rooster that's clear so that we have
some breathing room we're going to run
rooster and you're going to see that 65
is not less than
60 which is what we expect again if you
go up and change these numbers to
whatever you want try to change these
numbers to different values to see what
you get as output if we do this we're
going to see that number one is less
than 60 so this is going to be true
and we're going to have a true in this
result variable here if we go down
result is true this test condition here
is going to succeed and we are going to
fall in here let's click in our terminal
and hit enter we're going to run rooster
we're going to see 55 is less than 60
which is what we have here okay now i
hope you have a better idea of how you
can use the else close to make your if
statements really compact and this is
really cool okay another thing i want
you to see is that you can
not go through a variable like this and
use an expression as a condition
directly c plus plus allows you to do
this so what we're going to do we're
going to comment out what we just did
let's do that i'm going to use a block
comment i hope you know how to use this
already
and we're going to go down and put in
our code it is exactly the same thing
but we took the expression and put that
in the place of our condition variable
here because this is going to evaluate
to a boolean anyway so we can use this
as a condition and this is something
very legal to do in c plus plus so if we
run this we're going to see let's see
what we have in the numbers i have
forgotten
by now so 55 number one sixty number two
number one is less than number two this
is going to be true
so the test here is going to succeed and
we are going to fall in here that's what
we're going to say we're going to weld
with gcc as usual
and i'm going to clear and run rooster
and you're going to see that this is the
output we expect if we change up the
numbers again let's take this and make
it a 75 number one so number one
is less than number two is going to
evaluate to false the test here is going
to fail and we are going to fall in this
block here we're going to fall in the
else close of our test here we're going
to say
75 is not less than
55 is that what we have in there it's a
60 but this block here is going to
execute that's the most important thing
so we're going to run this and we're
going to try and clear and run rooster
we're going to get what we expect this
is one way we can do this and it is
really cool let's comment this out and
see another example and if we go down we
can see
the example we saw in the slides which
was using red green and
yellow
to simulate a traffic light
so what we really want to see here is
that we can nest stuff but before we do
that we need to
try and use these conditions because it
is just fun so if red is true meaning
that the red light is on we're going to
stop if yellow is true we're going to
slow down if green is true we're going
to go
and if we look at what we have here
red is false green is true false is true
and a police stop is true police stop is
not really being used so green is true
we're going to execute the green
statement here and we're going to say go
that's what we're going to say let's try
and run this
we're going to build with gcc
bring this up a little bit so that we
have some breathing room
and we're going to clear
and run rooster and you see that it is
saying
go here you can try and change these
boolean variables to different things
and see what is printed out here this is
a great way to learn but what we really
want to try here
is nested statements and let's go down
and do that okay again we don't want
what we have on top here to disturb us
so we're going to
comment this out and we are going to go
down and put in our code
for nested if statements
so what we're going to say
is if the light is green we should go
but the police officer has the right to
stop us even if the light is green at
least these are the laws in the country
where i leave so we have a variable
called police stop here so if they stop
you even if the light is green you're
going to stop and we're going to see
what we see here so if the light is
green we're going to fall in this body
again and we're going to run this inside
or nested if statement and if the
officer has stopped us we're going to
stop
if they haven't stopped us we're going
to go and go on our merry way this is
what we want to see here and again i
want you to stop for a moment try to run
this through your brain and try to come
up with the value we're going to see
when we run this in visual studio code
pause for a minute
we're going to run this
we're going to build with gcc
and we're going to run a program and you
see that police officer stops
stop
and why is that
the light is green okay so we we should
usually go but the police stop variable
here is also true so if we fall in here
this is going to execute and it is going
to succeed and we are going to say stop
and once this statement executes the
else statement is not going to execute
control is going to fall outside here
and we're going to keep doing whatever
we have outside this if statement here
this is really critical to understand if
one
block of a statement succeeds all the
others are not going to execute and try
to really understand this okay we have
seen this we can now comment this out
because we have something else i want to
show you
we're going to comment this out and
that's that you can combine the if
statements here or conditional
programming with the logical operators
we have learned about earlier in the
course and do really powerful stuff for
example here we can actually
not use this nested statement and do
this in one go like this and i think
this is much cleaner so we're going to
say if the light is green and the police
officer hasn't stopped us we're going to
go and if they have stopped us we're
going to stop and you're going to see
that we're going to get exactly the same
result that we had before but this is
really much more compact so we're going
to run and see the result of this and
we're going to clear clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
they're going to stop us and this is
really cool you can go
up again and change up these variables
to really anything you want and see what
you get trying to really understand what
is going on here it is not difficult and
the if statement is really fundamental
to any programming you're going to do so
this is really all we set up to do in
this lecture to learn about conditional
programming using the if statement it is
a powerful thing and you're going to see
it all over your software development
career so make sure you really
understand this but even if it's not
clear now we're going to have a chance
to do many examples and you're going to
really understand what this is all about
we are going to stop here in this
lecture the next one we're going to see
how we can use the else if close
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about the else if close that you
can attach to your if statement
and that's going to allow you to test
for several conditions in your if
statement
and
to really understand this suppose we are
building a drawing application and at
any given moment the user might be using
the pan or the marker or the eraser
already whatever tool that it is we
provide in our application
and if we want to draw
we need to know which tool is currently
selected by the user and we can do a
piece of logic like this we can have the
tool stored somewhere in our application
and when we get to the moment where we
want to do something for example when
the user clicks with the mouse and they
want to drag and start doing things then
we're going to test for the current tool
if the tool is the pan we're going to
use the settings for the pen if the tool
is the marker we're going to use the
settings of the marker and we're going
to keep doing this and select
one tool that is actually selected as
the current tool by the user and when
you do something like this only one
block in this whole chain of statements
is going to execute so for example if we
have the marker as the current tool the
code inside this block is going to
execute and say active tool is marker
but nothing else in this block is going
to execute after we run this statement
control is going to jump at the end of
this whole chain of if and else if
statements here i really hope you
understand this and uh this is really
powerful stuff for example
this is one of the applications i have
done in one of my advanced course about
qt and c plus qt is a framework that
allows you to do graphical user
interfaces like this and you can build
applications like this so what i did
here is i did the exact same thing that
we have here i had the chain of if and
else if statements and whatever tool
was selected as the current tool was
used to draw things on the canvas here
for example if the current tool was the
pen and the pen is this little pen tool
here if it is active we're going to draw
things like hello world here if we have
the star selected we're going to draw
stars if we have the rectangle selected
we're going to draw rectangles we could
do all kinds of crazy things using this
piece of logic here but it is powerful
stuff and you really have to make sure
you understand this so this is how the
else if clause can really help you the
main thing is to allow you to test for
several different conditions you could
do this with a lot of if statements but
that's not going to be really cool it's
going to be ugly and hard to read this
is what you should do
now that you have an idea about this
we're going to head to visual studio
code and actually see this in action
here we are in our working directory
we're going to grab our template project
pretty quick and we're going to use the
else if project here that's our current
project so we're going to do that and
open this up in visual studio code as we
always do we're going to open this up
we're going to open main cpp and we're
going to remove what we don't need
the first thing i am going to do is to
put in a set of variables that are going
to store our tools and we can do
something like this we have a variable
for pen marker eraser rectangle circle
and ellipse i have to say that this is
not the way to go about this we're going
to learn about another way we can do
this but that's going to be there in the
course when we have enough tools to
understand this for now we're just going
to be happy with this
okay 10 is going to represent the pan 20
is going to represent the marker 30 is
going to represent the razor and we can
go on until we hit ellipse which is
represented by 60. now if we go in main
and set up a variable and call it tool
for example and initialize it with
whatever tool we think that the user is
currently using for example we can use
circle and initialize this we can set up
a chain of s and else if statements to
do whatever it is we want to do when
this tool here is selected okay we're
going to go down and put in our code i
don't want to type all this so i'm going
to put this up here and if you want you
can copy the code from the
resource section the code is going to be
there you can copy it and paste it in
here and do things with that okay we
have a chain of if and else if close is
in here and the first one is going to
test and see if the tool is the pan and
notice that we are using double equal
signs here this is what you use to test
for equality you don't use one equal
sign you have to use two equal signs if
you use one equal sign that's going to
be an assignment and this is going to
always evaluate to true so you don't
want to do that again to test for
equality you're going to use double
equal signs in c plus plus so if the
current tool is the pen we're going to
say active tool span if the current tool
is marker we're going to say that so we
are basically going to do this for all
the tools that our application supports
so what do you think we'll see
when we run this the active tool is
circle
so we should print active tool is circle
here
let's try this out we're going to open
the terminal so that we can see the
output nicely and we're going to world
with gcc and the build is going to go
through if we run this we're going to
see active tool is circle you can go up
here and change the tool to rectangle
for example if you build again you're
going to see that the correct block of
code is going to be executed we're going
to clear and run rooster active tool is
rectangle if we try to put in something
that doesn't exist let's say let's put
in bird
just to mess with our compiler here
we're going to get a compiler error
because that type is not known by
our code here so we're going to get bird
was not declared in this scope we don't
know what it is you have to put in
whatever thing you have declared
beforehand here so if we put in a razor
for example we're going to weld with gcc
the world is going to go through going
to clear run rooster the tool is going
to be eraser and this is exactly what we
expect again the main message in this
lecture is that you can use this else if
close if you have several conditions
that you want to test for just like we
have here and again one of these blocks
is going to execute and once we hit the
end of this chain of if and else if
closes we're going to fall here and code
after that is going to execute so let's
say moving on so that you can really see
this here very clear moving on and if we
bolt this we're going to see only one
block from this whole chain and once one
block executes control is going to go
after all this chain and execute
whatever is after that so we're going to
say moving on after we print that the
active tool is eraser here i think we
have built this so let's
try and run this and you see active tool
is razer and moving on so after we print
the code from the eraser block we're not
going to execute rectangle or a circle
or ellipse it's going to jump at the end
of this whole block this is really
what i want to be
super clear and again make sure you
understand the syntax here the else if
statement is followed by a set of
parentheses and inside the parenthesis
we have the condition we want to test
for the condition has to evaluate to
boolean and after that we have the block
of code that we want to execute and this
is really all you have to do to get this
to work to your advantage
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
learn about switch
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about the switch statement and this is
an alternative way to do what we did
with these else if clauses in the last
lecture basically testing for several
different conditions but it's going to
be in a much more compact way than what
we did in the last lecture we are going
to be using the exact same example we
did in the last lecture and we're going
to look at the switch statement and how
it works in c plus plus and this is how
it works we have our variable which is
going to store the current tool and
we're going to say switch
inside the parenthesis here we're going
to
pass the variable that we're going to be
basically switching on or testing the
conditions on
and inside the block we're going to be
basically testing for each case so we're
going to say if the current tool is the
pan we're going to say case pan we're
going to put a colon in here and we're
going to put the code we want to execute
for the case
where the current tool is the pan in
these curly braces here and one thing
you should notice from the start is this
break statement here
this is a statement that tells c plus
plus
that after we successfully execute a
block of code we're going to jump out of
this switch statement if you omit this
break statement
everything after the case that you just
executed is going to execute and that's
not probably going to be what you want
if this is not making sense yet please
bear with me you're going to see it run
in visual studio code and you are going
to understand so what you're going to do
you're going to put all the tools you
want to test for in separate cases you
see here we have marker and after that
you can put a default case that is going
to be matched when nothing has been
matched in whatever it is you have
tested for in this switch block here and
when we run this piece of code we're
going to get exactly the same results
that we had in the last lecture but
hopefully you can see that this is much
more compact than the series of else if
closes that we had in the last lecture
again the break statement is really
useful if you don't put it in c plus
plus is going to be confused and after
you hit your successful case
everything after that is going to be
executed so the break statement is
basically telling c plus plus if you hit
it after a successful case is
jump out of this switch block because
you are done you don't have to do
anything else in here and another thing
you should know is that the condition
which is what we have inside this
parenthesis here can only be an integer
or an enum so basically it can be ant
long unsigned or car
basically every integral type we have
seen before but it can't be another type
such as string because that doesn't
really make sense so be sure to keep
this in mind
now that you have an idea about this
switch statement let's head to visual
video code and actually see this in
action here we are in our working folder
the current project is going to be
switch so we're going to grab our
template files and we're going to bring
that in here i'm going to go up a little
bit and open this up in visual studio
code as we always do and we're going to
open up our main file we're going to get
rid of what we don't need we are going
to go outside the main function here and
put in our tools just like in the last
lecture we are using integers each one
is represented by 10 20 30 up to 60 and
these are the tools we have and i don't
think i explained this but we are
flagging them const because we don't
want them to be modifiable we have seen
about const earlier in the course we are
going to jump into main and set up our
variable it's going to be ant and we're
going to call it tool and we're going to
initialize this whatever tool we want
let's use eraser why not and then we're
going to put in our switch block we're
going to say switch
and if i type this you see that visual
studio code is going to give me
intelligence or suggestions on what
thing i could do one cool thing that
visual studio code does is give you
snippets to really help you type things
out so we can click on this and it is
going to auto complete a starter version
of our case and we can type in our
expression here which is going to be
what we're going to be switching over so
we're going to switch over the variable
tool here and we can put in our cases so
in our case we're going to start with
pan which is what we have here so we're
going to say case pan we're going to
remove all this
uh let's remove this and say pen
i'm going to put a column
and we're going to put
a block of code that is going to execute
when the current tool is the pen and
we're going to put that in here let's
bring this
to the right a little bit and inside the
block we can say sddc out active tool is
pan okay so after that we're going to
put this break statement if it's not
here we're going to have a problem
because when the current tool is the pan
and this code here executes every case
after that is going to execute and
that's not what we want we have to
remember to put this break statement
here okay so we're going to put in all
our other cases so we're going to copy
this
and look at the next one it's going to
be marker so we can go on the next line
and put in marker we're going to paste
this in we're going to say marker and
we're going to say active tool is marker
and we can keep doing the same thing
we're going to go download them and
paste this in the next one is going to
be eraser so let's do that we're going
to say eraser and we're going to say
current tool is razer and we're going to
go down again
i am doing this live because it really
is important for you to see me type this
otherwise you may be confused because
this is a slightly confusing construct
we have in c plus plus the next one is
rectangle so we're going to use that and
we're going to say current tool is
rectangle the next one is going to be
circle and ellipse so let's do that
we're going to put in circle we're going
to go down and paste this in and bring
this back a little bit
and i'm going to say circle and we're
going to go down and put the next one in
which is going to be ellipse and after
that notice that video studio code also
inserted a default block and this is a
block that is going to execute when none
of the cases here
is head
so this is really important so you can
also add a block of code
and say no match found okay so we want
to see this print out and we're going to
try this out in a minute
okay after we do this we should get this
to work and do whatever we were doing in
the last lecture so the current tool is
going to be razer
the block here is going to be matched so
code here is going to execute
after that we're going to meet this
break and what it's really saying is
you have done what you have to do jump
out of this switch block here and we're
going to go to the end of this switch
block and we're going to execute
whatever is after that so just like in
the last lecture we can say moving on
and if we execute the program as we have
it now
it's going to say active tool is razor
and it's going to print moving on
let's bring up the terminal so that we
can really see this and we're going to
build with gcc the world is going to be
good and if we run rooster let's clear a
bit we're going to see that active tool
is a razor and we are moving on this is
really cool and it is exactly the same
thing we had
in the last lecture but now we are using
a much cleaner construct which switch
provides okay we can try to change the
tool and see that this really works we
can put in circle
why not i'm going to build with gcc the
world is going to go through as you see
here and if we run rooster we're going
to see active tool a circle we are
moving on you can try and change this
however you want if we put in ellipse
and world again we're going to build
with gcc and if we run we're going to
get active tool is pan and moving on why
is that ellipse we are saying active
tool is pen we didn't change that so we
just code a really bad bag here so let's
fix this and we're going to build again
i'm glad i found this so we're going to
clear and rooster
and we're going to see active tool is
ellipse and we are moving on
okay so let's see what could happen
if you forgot your break statement after
your case here so the current tool is
ellipse
and it is the last thing we have in here
so it's not a good test case
what i am going to do
is make the current tool the pen or the
marker let's use marker that's going to
do
and i am going to remove the break
statement here
okay so and i am going to remove all the
bread statements we have until we hit
the
last default
case
so we're going to go down
and we're even going to remove that for
the default case here
and if we both we're going to build fine
you're going to see that the world was
good but if we run this try to guess
what we're going to get the current
stool is the marker so we should print
marker
and hit the end of the switch block and
do moving on but let's see what we get
did we build let's build again just to
be sure so we're going to run rooster
and notice what happens
active tool is marker active thought is
eraser active tool is rectangle we
basically
print every other case after the macro
case is head
and if we try to change this for example
not use marker and use eraser let's
change this you're going to see that
we're going to
match the eraser case
and everything after that is also going
to execute and it is not what you want
so let's clear and run rooster you're
going to see eraser rectangle circle
ellipse and no match found so you have
ready to remember to put in this brick
statement i am going to hit ctrl z a
couple of times and bring those in and i
think this is enough we have to hit
again so that marker also has it and if
we run now we're going to get what we
expect let's try to use an eraser again
and if we both again and clear and run
rooster we're going to see active tool
is razer and we are moving on
this is what we expect okay this is
really how you work with a switch
block you have to pass in your
expression or your test case and you
catch each case using this case syntax
here you say case you pass in whatever
it is you want to match and you put a
column and you put your code inside this
block here and remember after each case
you have to add this break otherwise
everything else after this is going to
execute and it is not going to be what
you want before i let you go i want to
show you that you can actually group
these case statements if this is what is
making sense for your application so for
example
for
rectangle circle and ellipse
this can be grouped into the group of
shapes
so we can actually say
case rectangle
and uh put them on different lines
something like this so let's delete this
and say case rectangle
and we're going to delete the other
things
and say
case circle just like this and we're
going to say drawing shape i think this
syntax is supported in c plus plus okay
so let's try in world
and uh we're going to world with gcc
and the world is going to be good so if
we have a razor which is what we have in
here we're going to say drawing shape
let's clear
and run rooster
you're going to see drawing shapes
moving on we have grouped different
cases and handles them with one block
and this may come in handy in some
situations
one thing you should keep in mind is
that there are limitations on what you
can use as an expression or a condition
in your switch statement and that has to
be an integer something like ant car
unsigned shorter things like that we
have seen all of these things but it can
also be an enum but enam is something we
haven't learned about yet we will learn
about it later when we have enough tools
to understand that but know about this
limitation
so if we can in our project in visual
studio code for example and say
std string name and say
john for example and use this as a
switch condition or expression we have
to include string for this to work so
let's go up
and include the string library we're
going to do string and if we go down
again and try to do switch and use name
as an expression and take out everything
we have in here and try to compile this
you see that the compiler is not happy
okay it's going to say expression must
have an integral or enum type so this is
not even going to compile this is a
limitation you have and you have to make
sure what you pass as a condition here
is an integer something like ant or car
or other integral types we have learnt
about in this course
this lecture we're going to learn about
ternary operators and this is an
alternative way to do tests with the if
statement
suppose here we have a variable called
max we have two variables called a and b
and we want to find the maximum between
these two things
one easy way we can do this is say if a
is greater than b we're going to store
the maximum in max else then b is going
to be the maximum and we're going to
store that in our maximum value and
we're going to print this out if we do
this we're going to get whatever is the
maximum between a and b to be printed
out on the console and this is going to
work really well but we can also use a
ternary expression and the ternary
expression looks like this
and it starts with a pair of parentheses
you're going to put your condition
inside the parenthesis you're going to
follow that with the question mark
you're going to put your option one and
after that you're going to put a column
and option two and because this is a
statement in c plus plus we're going to
end this with a semicolon here is an
equivalent version of that
using f as we have been doing all along
so we say if condition results equals
option one if condition is false result
is going to be equal to option two and
this is exactly the same thing we are
doing with our ternary expression here
if the condition is true we're going to
take option one and assign that to
result if it's false we're going to take
option two and assign that to resort so
this is really a syntactic sugar or a
shorthand for this thing here and it's
going to make your code shorter and
you're going to see this all over the
place
in c plus plus code out there so you
really need to be
familiar with this okay so here is our
example of computing the maximum you see
that we have the same variables max a
and b but we have a one liner that is
going to store the maximum in max and we
can print this out
and hopefully you can see that this is
shorter and better than this okay one
other thing you should know is that
option one and option two should be of
the same type or at least the types must
be convertible and if that fails you're
going to get a compiler error we can
also do ternary initialization here we
have a boolean called fast
we initialize this to false we can use
this to
initialize our speed variable here we
are basically saying if fast initialize
this with 300 if not fast
initialize this with 150
and we're going to print the speed here
and this is going to work and here you
see that i lied a little bit in my
explanation to make it really obvious
what we had in our ternary expression
you don't have to always wrap your
condition in parenthesis but it makes
the code much cleaner okay now that you
have an idea about distance it's time we
headed to visual studio code and
actually tried this and so for ourselves
okay here we are in our working folder
the current project is ternary operators
we're going to grab our template files
and put those where they belong it is in
this lecture here on ternary operators
and we're going to open this up in
visual studio code as we always do we're
going to open this and we're going to
open main cpp and take out whatever we
don't need we are going to go down and
put in our test code we basically have a
few variables let's kill these spaces so
that our code is not cluttered here and
we're going to print our maximum
and we're going to be using a regular if
we have three variables max a and b we
are saying if a is greater than b
we're going to store the maximum and max
otherwise we're going to store b
in max
and this is going to allow us to print
whatever is the maximum between 35 and
20. if we build this let's bring up a
terminal
and we are going to build with gcc as we
always do let's bring this up a little
bit and we're going to clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
the maximum is 35 if we put our maximum
in a beam
we're going to get the maximum steel so
we're going to run this out to build
with gcc
and we're going to run this clear
rooster
max is 200 so we're going to get the
maximum regardless of where it is stored
in a or b this is how our code works but
we can use ternary operators to do the
same thing
so what we're going to do here we're
going to comment out our if statement
and use
a ternary version so what we're going to
do we're going to say result equals
and we're going to say a greater than b
we're going to put a question mark to
signal
the
start of our two options option one is
going to be a because if a is greater
than b then a is going to be the maximum
so we're going to grab a here and if a
is not greater than b
then b must be the maximum so we're
going to put that as a second option
here this is what we mean with this
statement and we don't have a variable
called results that's why we have a
problem here we're going to put our
result in max and this should
solve this problem
you see the squiggly lines go away and
we can build this and we're going to get
exactly the same result so this is our
ternary operator if we build this it is
going to go through and if we run this
we're going to get exactly the same
result max is 200 and it is what we
expect okay so take some time and really
make yourself familiar with this syntax
it is really nothing complicated you
just have to make sure your brain is
aware of something like this and you're
going to recognize that everywhere you
see it in code out there okay we have
mentioned that you can't pass types that
are not compatible and the requirement
is that a and b be of the same type
or at least types you can do conversions
between so for example if we try to do
something like
pass a hello in here
we can't really turn a strength into a
integer and this is going to give us a
compiler error and let's look at the
error we see from visual studio code
operand types are incompatible and and
the const car are not compatible and
they have to be compatible if we ignore
this and go ahead and build we're going
to also see an error from the compiler
and it should be the same error so
operands to
question mark and column have different
types and and cost car
and they have to be
stands you can really compare so for
example we can take out this string here
and put in a floating point let's put in
a 22.5 and say that this is a fluid
you're going to see that the problem is
going to go away here let's wait for a
minute it's not going away we're going
to build anyway you see the world is
good we're going to clear
so that we don't have all this clutter
you see problems by the way and if we
both again let's try to do that the
builder is going to go through and if we
run this we're going to get
max is 22 because we are comparing a and
22 here and the compiler inserted an
implicit conversion from this floating
point to integer that's why we are
seeing this here
so what is the type that's the compiler
really used here okay to make it really
clear what is going on we're not going
to
use max here let's say auto max one
and see what the compiler is really
deducing to
so we're going to take this out
and by this we're going to see
what implicit conversion the compiler
really did here because what we had
before we were doing an assignment so
whatever was on the left was being
turned into an integer because we were
doing an implicit conversion from an
assignment so whatever is on the left is
turned into the type of whatever we have
on the left of the assignment i hope you
know this already but if we do things
like this we're going to deduce whatever
is on the left and assign that into max
one so we're going to do so we're going
to see the implicit conversion that the
compiler did in here and it is good to
be able to see things like that it is a
curiosity thing so
let's see what happens here we're going
to print max one and i'm going to world
with gcc this is going to go through
and we're going to see what is printed
so let's run rooster
and you're going to see that the
implicit conversion happened from end to
flood and we deduce the flood here in
max one so this is really interesting
one might have thought that we had a
conversion from float
to end but it was actually the reverse
and this is quite interesting this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
again make sure you have this syntax
here drilled in your brain because
you're going to be seeing this a lot in
your career as a software developer not
only a c plus plus developer actually
and it is going to be helpful
for you to know this
congratulations on hitting the end of
this chapter this chapter was all about
flow control and we had the chance to
learn about many of the tools that c
plus plus provides to do conditional
programming and we were able to see all
kinds of crazy things we had the chance
to do things like if red is true we're
going to run the code inside if yellow
is true we're going to run code inside
if green is true we're going to run code
inside and you had a chance to play with
those things on many occasions we have
seen that the tools that c plus plus
provides really revolve around these
four things here we have if statements
we can do else closes
on this if statements we can do else if
to really do long chains of things where
we do different decisions to do things
in our applications we also saw that
switch is an option if you have several
decisions you can make in your
application and we saw that a ternary
operator can really be used to do
two decisions if you have two decisions
you're going to be able to reduce the
number of lines you used to do these
decisions with to one line and we had a
chance to really look at that in detail
in the lecture on ternary operators this
is really all i had to share in this
chapter i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next chapter we're going
to start and learn about loops
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this chapter we're going to be
learning about loops and this is a
construct that is provided by the c plus
plus programming language to allow you
to do repetitive tasks relatively easily
suppose we have a task to print a
message 10 times
we can go down and do it like this and
it is going to work but what if they try
and tell you
do this 100 times then you're going to
start scratching your head you're going
to type this 100 times and you're going
to run your program and it is going to
work then your manager comes up and they
say i want you to do this 10 000 times
or even 100 000 times and then you're
going to start pulling your hair or
running around breaking vents because
that's impossible to do not to worry
here c plus plus provides a way to do
this relatively easily and we're going
to be learning about ways we can do this
in our program in this chapter the
constructs we're going to be using are
these you see here there is a for loop a
range base for a loop a while loop and
do a while loop and we can make use of
these tools to not go crazy printing a
message one million times because that's
really bad
okay so that's what we are up against in
this chapter we're going to be learning
about these loop constructs and you're
going to find that they are really cool
for your application i am excited to be
teaching you this so let's get started
in the next lecture and learn about the
for loop go ahead and finish up here and
meet me there in this lecture we're
going to learn about four loops
for loops are one of the constructs we
have in c plus plus to do repetitive
tasks they allow us to do something like
this much more easily for example we
don't have to type stdc out of c plus
plus 10 times or 100 times we can do
this in less than five lines and you're
going to see how cool this is the syntax
for for loops looks like this and it may
look intimidating for first users but
we're going to break this down we have a
few parts in here the first part is the
iterator which is a variable that we're
going to be using to navigate through
the loop and that variable is this
unsigned int i here we are going to
initialize this to zero and the value we
initialize this with is going to be our
starting value and that's another key
point of any loop any loop is going to
have a starting point we are also going
to have a test which is going to control
when our loop ends for example this loop
is going to start with i equal to zero
it is going to keep doing stuff until
i is no longer
less than 10. as long as i is less than
10 it's going to keep doing whatever it
is we want to do and the first part of
the loop is this plus plus i thing here
and this is an incrementation part
that's how i'm going to call it for
simplicity but at least a part that
keeps changing our iterator to make our
loop move forward after these four
points we are going to have a pair of
curly braces and inside these curly
braces we're going to have the body of
our loop and this is the code we want to
execute multiple times and inside this
loop body we can really do all kinds of
crazy things you're going to see how
cool this is again we have a few parts
with our loop we have our iterator which
is this variable i here we're going to
be initializing this with a value that
denotes where we want our loop to start
we then have a test which is going to
control when the loop is going to end
we're going to have our incrementation
part which is going to allow our loop to
move forward and it's going to be doing
that through incrementation or
decrementation but to make explanation
easier here we're going to call this
part the incrementation part of the loop
after that we're going to have the body
of the loop and it's going to be within
this curly braces and it's going to be
whatever it is we want to execute inside
this loop okay these are the parts of a
loop and you need to keep this in mind
okay now that you know the main parts of
the loop
how does it really work let's go through
this and see how it's going to print i
love c plus plus 10 times so when this
code gets executed we're going to start
with i equal to 0 because that's what we
are initializing this value with
after the incrementation part we're
going to run the test
and the test is going to say is i is 0
less than 10 and that's going to be true
so if the test turns out to be true
we're going to jump into the loop body
and if it's false we're going to jump to
the end of the loop and execute whatever
is after our loop this is how it works
so if we jump in for the first time when
i is 0 we're going to print i love c
plus plus for the first time then after
the body is executed we're going to
execute the incrementation part
this is going to make i equal to 1 then
we're going to come back to the test
we're going to say is 1 less than 10
that's going to be true we're going to
come in the body and print i love c plus
plus for the second time after that the
incrementation part is going to run
we're going to have a 2 inside i here 2
is less than 10 this is going to be true
so we're going to follow him the body
again and print i love c plus plus for
the third time we're going to keep doing
this until we hit nine for example if we
increment and get a nine we're going to
form the test and say is nine less than
ten that's going to be true so we're
going to fall in here and print i love c
plus plus again
and after that we're going to run the
incrementation part again this time i is
going to become 10 we're going to do the
test 10 is not less than 10 so the test
is going to fail
and we're going to fall on the outside
of the loop here and by that time we'll
have printed i love c plus plus 10 times
and this is really how a loop works for
the first time we're going to run this
initializer part here to initialize our
iterator which is this value i
and then after that we're going to run
the test
if the test is good if it's successful
we're going to fall in the body we're
going to execute whatever code is in the
body and after that we're going to keep
doing the cycle increment test the body
increment test body
increment test body until
we hit a point where the test fails and
if the test fails we're going to fall
outside
this for loop here we're going to
execute whatever is after this closing
curly brace and this is how a loop works
i want you to go through this one more
time by printing i love c plus plus and
making sure that this is printed 10
times
and one thing you should have noticed
now is that we use this test to control
how many times the loop is going to
start for example if we wanted it to run
20 times we would start from zero and
and at 20. and you don't always have to
start from zero you can really start
from anywhere for example you can
initialize i with a value like 30 and
end when i is equal to 55. let's say
that as an example you can really do
anything the main important thing is to
understand how a loop works one thing i
want you to notice is that we are saying
unsigned int here
to declare our iterator
iterators are a common thing in c plus
plus code and they're not just used for
loops like we are doing it here there is
a type we use to do iterators and it
makes our code much more readable and
that's called size t
this event is a representation of some
unsigned and type in your c plus plus
compiler this is going to be different
from compiler to compiler but for
example on my system this is eight bytes
so it has quite a good range of values
you can put in there if we use size t
type to declare our i iterator here
we're going to say something like this
for size t i
we're going to put our curly braces
we're going to put a semicolon we're
going to put our test and we're going to
put our incrementation part and i think
i really emphasize this but the
parts of our loop inside this
parenthesis are separated by semicolons
like this so we have the iterator
declaration we have a semicolon we have
the test we have a semicolon and we put
our incrementation part and then we go
on and put our curlies and inside we can
do whatever it is we want to do
inside the loop so size t is something
you're going to see a lot make sure you
know what it means remember that it is a
representation of an unsigned and type
so it can only represent positive
numbers and it is used to represent
things like sizes in c plus plus thank
the number of students in a classroom
for example that can never be negative
think about the number of seats in a car
that's something that is always going to
be positive and it won't make sense for
that to be negative so for those kinds
of things we can use size t to represent
the size of those things and you're
going to see how this works in a minute
okay now that you have a pretty good
idea about how a loop works and the main
parts that make it up i want you to know
that you can also do all kinds of crazy
operations inside the body of your loop
for example here we are printing out the
current value of our iterator and we're
going to print the double that we can do
this we can also leave out the curly
braces and this is only valid if we have
one statement we want to run in the loop
so this is going to print this message
here five times because this loop is
going from zero all the way to four it
is going to stop when i stops being less
than five and this is going to be five
times if you go through this you're
going to see that this is going to print
five times you should also know that
this iterator that we are declaring like
this is going to be scoped inside the
body of the loop so you can only use it
inside these curly braces and if you try
to use it outside for example here after
the closing curly braces of the body of
the loop you're going to get a compiler
error again you can only use this
variable i which is our iterator
inside the curlies that mark the
start and the end of our loop body if
you want the iterator to be usable
outside the scope of the for loop you
can do something like this you can
declare your iterator outside the loop
and you can initialize that with
whatever you want and then you can set
up your loop like this you can say for j
and put and your test and your
incrementation part and inside do
whatever it is you want to do in the
body of the look if we do it like this
then j is going to be usable outside of
the loop and we're going to see its
value if we print it out like this so
this is also something you can do
you can even go all crazy and leave out
the
declaration part if you happen to have
iterator declared outside so if you do
something like this it is also going to
work okay the last thing i want you to
see before we head over to visual studio
code and actually try this out
is that it is a bad thing to hard code
your values in for example you see here
we are saying j less than 10
this is really bad design because every
time you need to change the number of
times that your loop is going to run
you're going to have to hunt for these
loops and change these values and this
may be in a lot of places in your code
so a good thing to do is to put the
value that controls how many times your
loop is going to run in a variable like
this we're going to store that value in
this count variable
notice that it is of size t because it
is a representation of the size of
things something we don't really want to
be negative and we're going to use this
in our test part of our for loop here
instead of saying j less than 10 we're
going to say j less than count and if we
want to change this we have one point of
control to go and change this value here
and this is really good design you
should do this okay we have talked a lot
about loops it is time we headed over to
visual studio code and actually tried
these things out here we are in visual
studio code the current project is for
loop here we're going to grab the code
from our template project
and we're going to put that in place
here
and we're going to open this in visual
studio code so let's do that pretty fast
for loop that's the current project we
selected and we opened this in visual
studio code
we're going to open up our main cpp file
which is going to show up here and we're
going to remove things we don't need
here
so let's remove that okay the first
thing i want you to do is the bad way to
do things
again if we want to print i love c plus
plus 10 times we can do it like this and
if we run the program it's going to work
but this is really bad design because
you would have to copy and paste this
for example a thousand times or even a
hundred thousand of times and that's
really bad so if we bring up our
terminal
and build with gcc like we always do
the build is going to go through you see
it's successful we're going to clear and
we're going to run rooster and it's
going to say lfc plus plus 10 times if
you count this it's going to be 10 times
because that's what we're doing here but
this is really bad design you don't want
to do something like this so we're going
to comment this out
and do this better using a for loop
let's say that this is the bad way and
we're going to use for loop which is the
good way sorry so we're going to start
by declaring our iterator so we're going
to say for we're going to say size t
let's use unsigned end to show you that
you can use that and we're going to say
i and we're going to initialize this
with a zero
and this is going to be the declaration
of our iterator this is the first part
we have in this parenthesis here we're
going to put in a semicolon and put in
the test we want the
loop to run ten times so it's going to
run from zero to nine we're going to
stop when i stops being
less than ten this is one way you can
understand this after we have our test
and we're going to put the
incrementation part which is going to
change the iterator to make the loop
move forward and we're going to do that
by incrementing our iterator after that
we're going to put a pair of curly
braces not angle brackets and we're
going to fall inside the body of the
loop this block here delimitated by the
curly braces is the body of the loop and
inside here we're going to put whatever
we want the loop to run so we can go
down here and say i love c plus plus 10
times let's say that but before we do
that let's say i so that we know the
current iteration where we are at
and we're going to put a column and say
i love c plus plus this is going to be
better to follow in the terminal i guess
and we're going to put in our
new line character
move to the new line
and we need to put our stream output
operator here for this to make sense to
the compiler and this is our loop now if
we run it we're going to see exactly the
same thing like this but we're going to
have these iterators prepended to the
message so that it becomes easy to
follow this and again how this is going
to work we are going to run our code to
declare and initialize the iterator
after that we're going to do the test we
are going to start with i zero so zero
is less than ten this is going to
succeed we are going to fall in the body
here
and after that we're going to
print sddc out i love c plus plus and
this is going to be zero we're going to
increment i
and we're going to do the test again
we're going to have to do is one less
than 10 the test is going to be
successful so we're going to fall in
here and we're going to print a one
and we're going to run the
incrementation part again we're going to
run the test and we're going to keep
doing this until we hit a point for
example when we increment this to be a
nine
and after that we're going to run the
test we're going to say is 9 less than
10 the test is going to be successful so
we're going to follow in here and we're
going to print nine
and after that we're going to increment
again we're going to run the
incrementation part and we're going to
make i 10 if we run the test we're going
to say is 10 less than 10 the test here
is going to fail we're going to stop
running the loop all together and we're
going to fall on the outside of the loop
and say loop done let's say that so that
we can see this on the terminal and this
is going to run and print i love c plus
plus 10 times and we expect i to go from
zero all the way to nine
try to run this in your mind
take a piece of paper try to
print this as you fall into the body of
the loop you're going to see that's
exactly what is happening here so what
we're going to do we're going to boil
this again so we're going to run the
task to
work with gcc
the world is good we're going to go down
and run this we're going to clear
and run rooster
and you're going to see that we have
zero i love c plus plus all the way to
nine i love c plus plus our loop is
working exactly the way we want okay so
this is the first step we are able to
run our code a lot of times without
really having to manually do things like
this and the benefit of this is that if
we want this to run for example 100
times all we have to do is change our
test
to go until i
is equal to 100 and we're going to stop
when i stops being
less than 100 and if we run this we're
going to see
the message from 0 all the way to 99 and
this is pretty cool the torso is going
to be 100 times so let's weld again to
show you how cold this is
we're going to run this task to weld
with gcc again
and we're going to clear
run rooster prepare to be amazed run and
it's going to run all the way to 99 we
can change this to even 1 000 or even 10
000 why not we're going to weld again
and we're going to be successful
and we're going to clear
and run rooster and this is going to go
all the way to 10 000 times we're going
to wait for this to get there
now 3 000 4 000 5000 6000 7000 8000
ten thousand it's going to go all the
way to nine thousand nine hundred ninety
nine and it is going to stop and the
total of times the loop run
was from zero all the way to
this storping number here okay now we
can see that our loop is really working
fine we don't have to do these hddc out
statements a crazy amount of times okay
and the benefit again is that
regardless of the number of times the
code here is going to run our loop is
going to stay relatively the same it's
just going to be one two three four
lines of code and this is really cool
okay so i think this now makes it very
clear how loops work so we're going to
comment this out and show you another
thing and we're going to show you that
you can use size t to actually
denote the type of your iterator
and it is easy to do that so we're going
to say use size t and for us to be able
to see all this here let's hit this file
icon here to close this pane and we're
going to have a better chance of seeing
our code here so what we want to do
we're going to declare a group we're
going to save for we're not going to say
our design and we're going to say size t
and this is going to be the type of our
iterator we're going to say i we're
going to initialize this with a zero
and we're going to put a semicolon like
we just did we're going to put in the
end test we're going to put in the test
so we're going to say i less than 10
no problem with us
and we are going to increment to put in
place our incrementation part we're
going to fall in the loop we're going to
say stdc out this is the code we want to
run so we're going to put in our
coverage value for the iterator and
we're going to say i love c plus plus
again and we're going to put in our new
line character and if we build and run
this it's going to work and run the same
so let's say loop done here
so that we know when it's done and we're
going to weld and run we're going to
world with gcc
the world is going to be good
and what we're going to do we're going
to clear
and run rooster and this is going to say
i love c plus plus 10 times from 0 to 9.
again the message here is that you can
use size t to represent the type of your
iterators and this is the type that is
even used in the c plus plus standard
library so this is going to be something
people expect from your code if you are
representing sizes in code that should
be compliant with the c plus plus
standard library nothing stops you from
using unsigned it like we do here but
we're just going to follow the
convention from the c plus plus standard
library and use this type here to
represent all sizes
and some of you might be wondering how
big is this thing we have the tools to
know
how big it is so let's do that pretty
fast so we're going to go down here
and say sddc out and we're going to say
size of
size t and we can print this out and
let's say what we are doing here so that
it is easy to
use this code as the reference and if we
print this out we're going to see
the size of this thing on the system
where this code here is going to run
so we're going to
build with gcc again
the bolt is going to be good we're going
to go here and clear and run rooster
you're going to see that it is eight
bytes on my system so you're going to
have quite a huge range of numbers you
can put in here because this is going to
only be positive
okay if you try to put in a negative
number you're going to get an underflow
and we have learned about overflow and
underfloor in the previous chapter
okay so let's comment this out and keep
learning more things about for loops
okay the next thing i really want you to
focus on and learn is the scope of the
iterator and we're going to grab our
code again here
so that we can use this
as a learning tool so we're going to go
down here and put that in
and what we're going to have let's move
this a little bit to the right i think
we can do something like this i am going
to select the entire thing here and hit
tab and it is going to be aligned with
whatever we have here
okay so we have our loop it is going to
run 10 times it's going to print i love
c plus from 0
to 9
but
what is the scope of this i think here
and the fact is it is scoped inside this
loop here you might have guessed that if
you try to use it outside the loop
you're going to get a compiler arrow
because it is only usable inside the
body of the you can also use it inside
the control part of the loop here but
you can't use it outside the loop so if
you try to print i here for example
you're going to get a compiler error so
let's try and do that and show you how
wrong this can be
so if we try to print i here let's say i
to make it clear what we want to print
if we try to do this we're going to get
a compiler error because i is not in
scope it is only in scope inside these
curly braces that show the body part of
our loop okay visual studio code is
showing the problem here it's saying
eyes undefined here so you shouldn't
really do this but if we move on and
ignore the message from visual studio
code and compile
we're going to get a compiler error and
it's going to say
i don't know what you're doing here i
was not declared in this scope where you
are using it and i think it's even going
to give me a line a number it's going to
tell me 46 that's where you are doing
something wrong and if we go in our code
we're going to see that this is the line
where we are making the mistake so i is
not in scope here we're going to comment
this out and say compiler error i is not
in scope that's what you're going to get
if you try to do this and the main
message is that if you declare your loop
like this ah is only going to be scoped
in the body of the loop and that's the
only place where you can mention its
name and use it if we comment this out
and world again the compiler error is
going to go away you're going to see
that the world is good let's clear so
that our output here is good
we're going to build again and show you
that the build is good and uh this is
really cool both finished successfully
okay this is one way we can set up our
loop but there is a way we can make our
iterator usable outside the body of the
loop and we're going to show you how you
can do that next so let's comment this
out and go down again
and we're going to grab the code because
we don't want to type all this again and
we're going to say iterator declared
outside the loop we're going to go down
and put in our code
and we're going to align this nicely
and we're going to take the iterator and
declare it on the outside of the loop so
we're going to say size t
and we're going to say i and initialize
this to 0
and we're going to say this very clearly
iterator
defined
outside
and we're going to say in our
[Music]
declaration part of the iterator we're
going to just say i and this is going to
work pretty fine if we build this you're
going to see that the world is good and
if we run this it's going to do the same
thing it's been doing it's going to
print i love c plus plus 10 times and if
you want i usable on the outside of the
loop now you can use it we can grab the
code here that was failing
in the last run of our code and put that
out here and we're going to align this a
little bit
and if we compile this the book is going
to be good
and if we try to run rooster we're going
to see i love c plus 10 times we're
going to say loop done and we're going
to print the value of i and you see that
if we do things like this i is going to
be usable on the outside of the loop
body
and sometimes these may come in handy
depending on the logic of the
application that you are designing just
know that this is something you can do
in your loops
okay you can go even crazier and leave
out this iterator declaration part in
your loop all together so you can remove
that and we're going to show you how you
can do that in a minute so let's comment
this out i don't want to remove code
because i want you to have this as a
reference if you need to look at this
later so we're going to say leave out
and what you can do is grab the code we
had before i'm going to grab it
and we're going to paste that in here
and what we're going to do is take out
this eye this can work and you may see
code like this out there in the wild so
we're going to run this task to build
with gcc the world is going to be good
and we're going to clear and run rooster
and it's going to do exactly the same
thing so this is one way you can set up
your loops okay the last thing we need
to see about loops is that
this test here is using a hard coded
value and if we needed to change this
loop to run for example for a thousand
times we would need to manually hunt for
this line of code change this and this
is really not good design so what is
recommended is to store this value in a
variable and test against that variable
name instead
let's comment this out and show you that
so we're going to
comment this out
and go down and copy this entire thing
i don't think i want to do my loops like
this because this is really unintuitive
most times so i am going to declare my
iterator inside and i'm going to copy
the code that does that here we're going
to go down
and say
don't hardcord values okay we're going
to say that it's really bad
and we're going to go down and show you
a better way to do things and again
right now we are hard coding in this
value but we can say const
size t
and we can call this value count for
example and we can initialize it with
whatever we want in this case we want to
control our loop to run 10 times so
we're going to put in a 10 and instead
of hard coding and this 10 we're going
to say count
okay
and if we build and run it the loop is
going to do exactly the same thing it's
going to print i love c plus plus 10
times
so let's do that
and run rooster
it's going to do the same thing but now
we have one point of control if we want
this to run for let's say 100 times we
can change the count value to 100 times
and if we both again that's how many
times the loop is going to run and this
is much cleaner so i do recommend you
store
the values you use in your loops in
variables like this and it's going to
make your code look better
so it's going to run 100 times and this
is exactly what we want
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you found it
interesting
i am sorry that this lecture turned out
lengthy because we had a lot of things
to talk about but now i hope you really
know a lot of things about ways you can
use your for loops to make them do
things and again many loops that we're
going to use in our c plus plus code are
going to have five parts we're going to
have an iterator which is going to be a
variable we use to manipulate how a loop
moves forward and does things the
starting point is going to be where the
loop is going to start we're going to
have a test in place which is going to
control when the loop ends and we're
going to have the end point encoded in
that test we're going to have the
incrementation part of the loop which is
going to control how our loop moves
forward and we are going to set up a
pair of curly braces that are going to
contain the body of our loop in this
lecture we're going to learn about while
loops and this is another construct we
have in the c plus plus programming
language to allow us to do repetitive
tasks the syntax for a while loop looks
like this we have five parts in our loop
we have the iterator the starting point
the test the incrementation and the loop
body it's just going to be set up
differently for while loops the iterator
is declared on the outside and you see
here we have unsigned in i which is
exactly the same type of iterator we've
used in the last lecture but know that
you can also use size t here i am just
using unsigned and for this case after
you have your iterator declared you're
going to fall to this part here and say
while open a set of parentheses and
inside you're going to put in your test
after that you're going to open a pair
of curly braces and design them you're
going to put the body of your loop
and you're going to do whatever it is
you want to do in the loop in there and
after your code to do whatever it is you
want to do is executed you're going to
put in your incrementation part after
you code and that's what we have here
and this is the setup we're going to be
using for our while loops again
we have the
iterator declared on the outside and we
can initialize it with whatever it is we
want to
start with
then we're going to put in our test it's
going to be within this parenthesis and
after that we're going to set up a pair
of curly braces and inside them we're
going to put whatever code we want to
run in the loop and then we're going to
follow that with our incrementation part
and if we try to run this we're going to
run this line we're going to declare the
iterator i and it's going to start with
zero so the test is going to run and 0
is less than 10
and we're going to succeed and we're
going to run the body here we're going
to say i love c plus plus and after that
we're going to run the incrementation
part i is going to become one we're
going to run the test again so one is
less than 10 we're going to succeed
we're going to fall in print i love c
plus plus we're going to increment again
then we're going to have a 2 in i here
we're going to run the test again we're
going to say is 2 less than 10 that's
going to be true so we're going to be
successful we're going to fall in the
body of the loop we're going to
increment and get a three we're going to
test against our three value three is
less than ten we're going to succeed
we're going to print i love c plus plus
we're going to increment again we're
going to test again and we're going to
say is for less than count or 10 we're
going to be successful and we're going
to keep running until we increment and
get a 9. once we get a 9 we're going to
run the test again and we're going to
say is 9 less than 10 that's going to be
successful so we're going to fall inside
print i love c plus plus we're going to
increment and get a 10
and if we run the test again i'm going
to say is 10 less than 10 that's going
to fail and we are going to fall on the
outside of the loop and we're going to
run whatever code is on the outside here
this is really how a while loop works
and i hope you can see the similarities
between the for loop we have seen it is
really the same thing we just have
different syntaxes to do these things
okay if you look at these things we
already have the same pieces of
information it is just different
syntaxes that c plus plus provides to do
the same things and sometimes you're
going to find it convenient to use while
loops and sometimes you're going to find
it convenient to use for loops and
you're going to have to decide what
works better for whatever it is you are
working on for now we're going to head
over to visual studio code and try this
out okay here we are in visual studio
code the current project is while loop
we're going to grab our template files
and we're going to go in our project and
put those in
and we're going to open this in visual
studio code so let's do that
we're going to open the folder
and we're going to work on while loop
here we are going to open our main cpp
file pretty quick and we're going to get
rid of this and what we're going to do
is remove what we don't need and again
we're going to show you the bad way to
do things you don't really want to do
this manually we want to print i love c
plus plus 10 times
so
we're going to build let's bring up a
new terminal so that we can
use this when we run thanks and we are
going to world with gcc let's do that
pretty quick the world is good
so we can clear and run rooster and
we're going to have i love c plus
printed out 10 times so what we can do
is comment this out and use a while loop
like we want to do in this lecture here
and as we have seen with the slides
the first thing we need to do is declare
our iterator on the outside so we're
going to say size ti we're going to
initialize this with zero
and that's going to be our iterator
declaration and we're going to say while
i is less than the value where we want
to stop and again we don't want to hard
code these values and so what we're
going to say is really
const size t and we're going to call
this count and make it uppercase this is
a convention we use to declare constants
in c plus plus but you don't have to
make them uppercase it is just a
convention that is going to make your
code easier to read for other people so
we're going to
put a 10 in here because we want our
loop to run 10 times
and we're going to say y i
is less than count and we're going to
set up a pair of curly braces and they
are going to delimitate
the start and the end of the body of a
loop here and inside we're going to put
in whatever code we want the loop to run
multiple times and the code is now very
familiar we're going to say sddc out
and we're going to print the
current iteration and we're going to say
i love c plus plus sdd endl for our new
line character and after that we will
need to put in our own incrementation
part if you forget that you're going to
get something really bad happen we're
really going to look at that later in
the chapter but for now remember to put
the incrementation part and we're going
to say plus plus i this is really easy
and we're going to say that this is the
test
and this is going to do what we want but
let's go down here and say that loop is
done when it is done so we're going to
say loop done
and we're going to say stdendya
and before we run this we're going to go
through it and see how it is going to
work so let's click on this file icon
here to close this pane so that we have
some breathing room i am going to open a
notepad file we're going to use to see
these things really happen
when this loop runs we're going to
initialize the iterator here what we're
going to do is put in a 0 and we are
going to run the test to see if 0 is
less than 10 and the test is going to be
successful so we are going to fall in
here and say
0 i love c plus plus so let's say that
here to make this super clear inside the
loop we're going to print this message
zero i love c plus plus and after we
execute this line we're going to
increment i is going to become one we're
going to go up again and run the test
and we're going to say is 1
less than count or is 1 less than 10.
the test is going to be successful we're
going to run inside the loop and we're
going to print 1 i love c plus plus
that's what we're going to do here so
let's do that
and after we do that we're going to run
our incrementation part again
i is going to become two we are going to
run the test we're going to say is 2
less than 10 that's going to be true of
course and we're going to fall in the
body again and say two i love c plus
plus
so let's say that
we're going to increment and we're going
to get a three we're going to run the
test again the test is going to be
successful because three is less than
ten we are going to fall in here and say
three i love c plus plus okay so we can
really follow this
and we are going to increment to get a
four and the test is going to say is
four less than ten that's going to be
true so we're going to succeed and
following the body again and we're going
to say 4 i love z plus blocks
we're going to keep doing this and we're
going to increment again we're going to
get a 5. the test is going to run again
we're going to say is 5 less than 10
that's going to be true of course and
we're going to run the code to print
five i love c plus plus
we're going to increment again to get a
six
we're going to run the test we're going
to say is 6 less than 10 that's going to
be true of course again and we're going
to print sets i love c plus plus and
we're going to increment to get a 7
we're going to run the test our iterator
we're going to say is 7 less than count
that's going to be true we're going to
print the message again and say seven i
love c plus plus and we're going to
increment again to get an eight we're
going to say is eight less than and
count
that's going to be true we're going to
fall in the body and say eight i love c
plus plus we're going to increment to
get a nine
we're going to run the test against our
nine of course nine is less than ten so
that's going to be true we're going to
fall inside and we're going to say nine
i love c plus plus
and after that we're going to increment
again and we're going to get a 10.
now if we run the test we're going to
say is 10 less than 10 and that's going
to be false because 10 is not less than
10 and if the test here fails we're not
going to fall in the body of the loop
control is going to fall at the end of
the loop body and we're going to print
loop done that's what we're going to say
here we're going to say loop
done and our loop will have run 10 times
by the time we print this loop down
message here if you count here you see
that the loop is going to run 10 times
and it is going to say i love c plus
plus 10 times which is really what we
want okay i really had to show you this
manually so that you can really see what
is happening but now we can weld and run
this and let the computer do the heavy
duty of running this and showing us all
these messages
so the build is going to be successful
of course
we're going to run rooster and it's
going to exactly show the same thing we
just came up in our trusty notepad file
here you see it is the same thing but
the beauty is that we don't have to do
all these crazy computations again what
we can do is we can even change the
count to 100 so it is going to run for
100 times
that's pretty cool
so we can
clear and run rooster and is going to do
that 100 times and that's pretty fast
for computers
this is really all we had to share with
you in this lecture the main thing is to
learn about the syntax of a while loop
and again notice that we have these five
parts that make up our loop we have an
iterator we have the starting point we
have a test we have the incrementation
part and we have the loop body it is
just set up differently with a while
loop like we can see here in this
lecture we're going to learn about do
while loops and this is yet another
construct we have in c plus plus to do
repetitive tasks
let's look at the syntax here we have
our declaration of the iterator on the
outside and after that you're going to
say do you're going to put a pair of
curly braces like this you're going to
put whatever code it is you want to run
inside the loop and then you're going to
do your incrementation and after the
closing curly brace you're going to say
while and you're going to put in your
text this is really the structure again
notice that we have those five parts and
this is the
declaration of our iterator and we're
going to initialize this in place for
example if we want to do that
after that we're going to
fall in the body of the loop
and after that we're going to do the
incrementation after we run the code it
is we want to run in the body of the
loop and then we're going to do the test
later and the special thing about a do
while loop is that it is going to run
first and then you do the test last
this is really something you need to be
careful about make sure that when it
runs it is doing whatever it is you want
to do because the test is going to run
after your code has actually run and you
can tweak this to do whatever it is we
want it to do as we are going to see
when we hit visual studio code in a
minute okay again one thing you need to
keep in mind is that the do while loop
is going to run the body
of the loop and then do the check or the
test and that may come in handy in some
of the applications you'll be doing
within your career as a c plus plus
developer okay this is really the syntax
we're going to be using we're going to
head over to visual studio code and play
with us okay here we are in our working
folder the current project is going to
be do while loop
we're going to grab the template files
pretty fast and we are going to put them
in our current project let's open this
up and put them in there
and we are going to open this in visual
studio code do while loop is our project
we're going to open this and the main
cpp is opened up so let's remove
whatever it is we don't need and we are
going to show you the bad way to do
things the bad way to do things is
typing your code to do things manually
if you wanted them to be done multiple
times and this is something bad if we
bought this and run we're going to go
down and run this clear not
that's g brush we're going to run
rooster
and we're going to get i love c plus
plus 10 times and you don't want to do
something like this what we want in this
lecture is to use
do while loops to solve this problem
we're going to comment this out because
it is really bad
and we're going to go down and set up
our do while loop the first thing we
need to do is to set up the count
because we want to store this in some
variables so we're going to say const
and
count
and we're going to put in our value
let's put in a 10
not 190 we're going to say 10 times
and we're going to set up our iterator
we're going to say size t
and we're going to say i and initialize
this with our starting point we're going
to start from zero
and what we're going to do is say do
and put a pair of curly braces
and inside this pair of curly braces
we're going to put whatever it is we
want to do
multiple times so we want to print i
love c plus plus so that's what we're
going to say we're going to
put in the current iteration
and we're going to put a column and say
i love c plus plus
and then we're going to jump to the new
line with stdendl
and after that we don't want to forget
our incrementation part so we're going
to say plus plus i
and this is going to be
the part that moves our iterator to the
next step this is going to be the
incrementation and this is going to be
the iterator
declaration
and after the closing brace we need to
say our test
so we're going to say while and we're
going to put in our test here and we
want to keep doing this as long as i is
less than count of course
and we're going to put in our closing
semicolon here
now this code is going to run 10 times
but let's go through how it's going to
run so that you can really see
everything
that is happening here okay so when this
code here is run we're going to hit the
initialization line here we're going to
declare i and we're going to put in a 0.
we're going to say do and inside we're
going to print whatever we have in i and
say i love c plus plus so we're going to
say 0 because i is 0 at this point and
we're going to say i love c plus plus
and after that we're going to increment
i is going to become one
and we are going to do the test at this
time
we're going to say is one less than ten
that's going to be successful so we're
going to run the body again
and we're going to say 1 i love c plus
let's copy this and print this again so
that we don't have to type this all the
time we're going to say 1
i love c plus and after that we're going
to run the incrementation part again so
we're going to get a 2 inside i we're
going to test and say is 2 less than 10
that's going to be true so we're going
to run the body again and print 2 i love
c plus plus
and we're going to increment to get a
three in there
we're going to run the test against our
three is three less than ten that's
going to be true so we're going to fall
in the body again and print three
i love c plus plus let's do that we're
going to do the incrementation we're
going to get a 4 inside this i variable
here we're going to run the test we're
going to say is 4 less than 10 that's
going to be true of course we're going
to say four i love c plus plus when we
fall in the body again
we're going to do the implementation and
get a five we're going to do the test
it's five less than ten that's going to
be true so we're going to fall in the
body again and say five i love c plus
plus
let's say that
we're going to increment again
we're going to get a six the test is
going to run and we're going to say is
six less than ten
that's going to be true again then the
body is going to execute and say
6 i love c plus plus we're going to do
the incrementation and get a 7. we're
going to run the test against our 7 so
we're going to say is 7 less than 10
that's going to be true
we are going to fall in the body again
and say 7 i love c plus plus
we are going to do the incrementation we
are going to get 8 we're going to say is
8 less than 10 that's going to be true
we are going to fall in the body again
and say 8 i love c plus plus we're going
to do the incrementation we're going to
get a 9 and we're going to run the test
we're going to say is 9 less than 10
that's going to be true so we're going
to go inside and say 9 i love c plus
plus
and we're going to do the incrementation
again now we're going to get a 10 and
the test is going to say is 10 less than
and that's going to be false now the
test is going to fail
and we're going to fall after the while
loop here so if we had a statement here
that said stdc out loop done we would
print that we would go down here and say
loop done
and this is what we're going to get if
we run this program and again i
encourage you to try this out in your
mind print this in some file you have on
your computer or you can even use a
regular piece of paper but make sure you
understand the flow we go through to get
this code to run multiple times okay now
that we have done this we can work this
and let the computer
do the heavy work for us and run this
fence multiple times the world is going
to be good so what we're going to do
we're going to say clear
and run rooster and it's going to say
exactly what we expect i'll have c plus
10 times and then it's going to say
loop done okay one thing i want you to
see
is that the do while loop runs before it
does the test and this may cause crazy
things happening in your program if
you're really not careful
let's say that you wanted this program
not to run and initialize this thing
with a zero for the count so it's going
to run zero times but that's not going
to do what you expect with the do while
loop because
it runs things before it does the test
so if you run this program it's not
going to just say loop done it's going
to say i love c plus plus and have zero
value in here and it's going to say loop
done but
that's not going to be probably what you
intended by putting a zero in here you
put a zero in here if you want this code
to run zero times or the code in the
body not to run that's another way to
say that but in this case a do while
loop is not going to do what you expect
because it runs before it does the test
here
let's build this and show you this
so we're going to go through the world
is successful
and we are going to clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
it's saying zero i love c plus plus loop
done it is running even if we set our
count to zero here so be sure the do
while loop is doing what you want but if
you are careful about this
you're going to have no problems and if
you want the rope to actually not do
anything
when you have zero counting here you can
use the while loop or the full look like
we have seen before
i would like to welcome you in this new
chapter
where we're going to be learning about
arrays and arrays are a way to
set up collections in our c plus plus
program so far we have been working with
single variables for example you have a
bunch of integer variables you can even
have 10 or 20 variables of integer type
and that's going to be fine but
sometimes you don't want to manage all
these variables it is really desirable
to group all these variables into one
single unity and manage them as one
single entity and we can do something
like this group them together and give
them a name so that we can refer to them
or manipulate them
under this name here and c plus plus has
the array construct to help us do this
okay so again if you look in memory how
things are laid out you're going to have
a bunch of zeros and ones for example
here each red defend is a net it is four
bytes in size and it can be used to
represent a net so if we have a bunch of
events like this we might want to group
them together and give them a name and
manipulate them under this name this is
another way to look at what we just
talked about here and again arrays are a
way to do these kinds of things in c
plus plus and we're going to be learning
all about it in this chapter we are
going to stop here in this lecture and
we are going to start and look at how
you can declare and initialize an array
in the next lecture
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to see how we can declare and use
arrays in our c plus plus program and
again arrays are a facility we have in
the c plus plus programming language to
group many variables together and
manipulate them as a single unit for
example here we have a bunch of integers
in memory each of these red things is
going to be four bytes in size so we can
think of it as an integer and we can
group them together and give them an a
we call them scores here and they are
going to be living under that scores
entity so if we want to
refer to each of these things z plus
plus provides an indexing system so we
cannot use angle brackets like this and
refer to the first of these integers as
zero so we can go from zero all the way
to nine here but your array can even be
bigger than this many times bigger than
this and we're going to see examples of
how we can do that but this is an
example of how you can take many
variables group them under one entity
give them a name and be able to
reference each of these events that are
under that entity and now that the idea
is pretty clear let's see how we can do
this in c plus plus the way to do that
is to say and you have to specify the
type of your collection you have to
specify the name after that and then
you're going to put a pair of angle
brackets like this and inside those
angle brackets you can specify the size
you want that collection to have or that
array to have and after this statement
is run we are basically going to have
something like this in memory we're
going to have 10 integers so if you
count here 0 all the way through 9
that's 10 integers they're going to be
grouped together under one logic entity
that logic entity is going to be called
scores and we can go through that name
to manipulate all these things that are
in this entity okay after your array is
declared and you have space for it in
memory basically something like this we
need a way to read data from at and
we're going to see how we can do that
and it is what we have here for example
if we want to print the first of these
elements we're going to say scores
angle brackets and specify the index of
the first element in that array or that
collection of integers that is called
scores okay one thing you should really
keep in mind is that arrays are indexed
from zero they don't start from one so
the first element is going to live at
index zero it's not going to live at
index one so here scores zero is going
to print the first element and scores
nine is going to print the last element
which happens to be the last in our
collection here of integers okay once
our array is declared it's not going to
have data in it there is going to be
data in but it's not going to be data
that we put in so we can think of this
data basically as garbage another thing
i wanted to bring to your attention is
that
your array has clear boundaries when we
declare an array like this notice that
we specify 10 as the size of our array
it's only going to have 10 elements
inside and you can see that we have from
index 0 all the way to 9 and inside we
have garbage data but we're going to fix
that in a minute what i want you to see
here is that you can to try and read
outside the bounds of your array
c plus plus is funny in that it allows
you to do that but if you do that you're
going to get weird problems for example
your program would crash or do something
really bad so you shouldn't really do
this be aware of the boundaries of your
array if you try to read the data from
the outside of your balance you may read
garbage data you may even cause failure
of the operating system because you
don't really know whose memory you're
reading it's not going to be memory that
is allocated to your program so array
boundaries are something you need to
keep in mind when working with arrays
okay we just saw that we could read data
from the array using this angle bracket
syntax we can even do that through the
loops and
read all the elements in the array and
this is how we could do that and you can
see that the loops we learned about in
the last chapter
are starting to come in handy okay we
have seen how we can read data from the
array
but what if we want to put something
back in what if we want to write our own
data in an array well the syntax is
pretty much what you would expect we
also use this angle bracket syntax but
we're going to assign data to that
element in the array for example if we
wanted to assign data to the first
element in our array we're going to say
scores
angle brackets 0 and we're going to
assign a 20 in it and we can assign a 21
into the element at index 1 and the 22
in the element at index 2 and if we do
that we're going to have something like
this in our array so index 0 we have a
20 index 1 we have a 21 index 2 we have
a 22 and the rest is still garbage
because we didn't put in our data we can
also write data in a loop for example
here we have our array declared
and we're going to loop around putting
data at different indexes notice that
the index is going to be the current
iteration we are at so this is a common
way to do things in c plus plus and you
need to be familiar with this and after
we put in the data we can read that back
and make sure that it is the actual data
that we put in and we're going to have a
chance to play with this in visual
studio code in a minute so don't worry
if some of these things don't make sense
yet but again the main thing here is
this angle bracket syntax we can use
that to either write data in the element
of the array or read data from the
element of the array and this is the
syntax here scores angle brackets i okay
so far our array has been declared and
we didn't really put in data and there
was junk data inside but there's a way
you can declare an array and put data in
in one single statement and this is how
you would do it here we have another
array it's going to be grouping double
variables
we call the array salaries and we
specify that it's going to be
of size five and we can put these
elements in a comma separated list using
braced initialization like this and it
is going to work if we try to print it
out we're going to see these elements
here and you see that we can read this
using the same syntax we've learned
about salaries we say the array name we
do angle brackets and inside we put the
index of the element we are reading from
and this index is coming from our loop
here and it is going to work you're
going to get this element printed out
this is pretty cool when initializing
your array
you can leave out elements for example
here we have a neat array it is called
families it's going to be of size 5 but
we are just putting in three elements
the rest are going to be initialized to
zero when we do things like this and
this is something you need to be aware
of and we are going to try this out in
visual studio code and you're going to
see that this is actually true it is
possible to also omit the size when you
are declaring your array and the
compiler is going to deduce the size
from the elements that you initialize
your array with for example here we have
in one two three four five six elements
this array is going to have a size of
six and if we print elements we're going
to get those printed out notice here
that we are using a ranged base for loop
and
hopefully you can see that it is easier
to read data from a collection like this
using a ranged base for loop because we
don't have to set up an iterator
initialize it to do the test do the
incrementation we can just read the
value and use it and be on our merry way
this is pretty cool it is possible to
also declare your array constant and
when you do that you won't be able to
modify elements of that array
that's what it means if you make it
constant you basically want it to stay
constant and you don't want to allow
modifications of your array and we're
going to see this in a minute when we
get in visual studio code the last thing
i want you to see is that you can
actually do operations on the data that
you have stored in an array for example
here we can sum the elements up and
store the result back in our variable
sum and this is something you would do
and it might come in handy in many times
okay one thing i want you to see before
we head over to visual studio code and
play with us is that arrays store
elements of the same type
repeat after me arrays store elements of
the same type you can't try and store
variables of different types in an array
i don't even know how you would actually
declare that and if you try and store a
different type
than the type that was declared for the
array you're going to get a compiler
error so this is something you should
keep in mind but it makes sense because
when you declare an array you're going
to be given a bunch of bytes in memory
and those bytes are going to be
collections of data that is of the same
type for example here we have a bunch of
integers again each of these red events
is an integer and if you try to put in
something that is smaller or bigger than
an edge then the compiler is going to be
confused that as to how to read these
text so for arrays to work the types
that you store in the array have to be
the same and they need to be consistent
this is something you should know and if
you try to break this rule you're going
to get a compiler error
now that you know about arrays we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and play with them a little bit okay
here we are in our working folder the
current chapter is raised the current
project is declaring and using arrays
we're going to grab our template code
and we're going to copy and move the
files over
and we're going to open this thing up in
visual studio code pretty quick we're
going to open up the main cpp file and
remove things we don't need
and we're going to see how we can
declare an array of ants
okay the way you do that you say the
name of the arrays and you put these
angle brackets and specify the size of
your array if you want you can put a
space in here it's really not going to
make a difference and you're going to
put a semicolon at the end the moment
this line executes we're going to have
the space for 10 integers allocated to
us in memory and that space is going to
be called scores and we're going to be
able to read data from it or even write
data back into it for now let's see how
we can read the data and it is really
simple we're going to use this angle
bracket syntax that we just saw in the
slides so if we want to read the first
element we can say
sddc out we want to print it out and
we're going to say scores
specify the index we want to read from
so we say zero
and we're going to say std endl to move
to the next line if you have this typed
out you're going to see that this is
going to work and it is going to print
whatever is stored in the first element
in this array here and again i want you
to keep in mind the memory structure of
your data when you are working with
arrays so what we're going to print
right now is whatever junk data is in
this first element here okay in here
we're going to say that we haven't
jumped yet
and let's bring up a terminal
so that we can play with us and we're
going to build this with gcc as we
always do
the build is going to be good
and we're going to clear
and run rooster you see that this is the
junk value we have in here we don't have
any
useful data in here it's just junk data
because we didn't initialize this array
we can also read the element at location
two and see what we have in there when
you run the program i'm not even sure if
it is guaranteed that you're going to
get the same data if you run the program
multiple times but we don't really care
we know that it is junk data so we can't
use this in our program
what we're going to do is run this
and see the value for the element at
index one
let's build with gcc
the world is going to be good we're
going to clear
and we're going to run rooster and
you're going to see that at index 1 we
have a zero end
but
doing it manually like this is really
time consuming and it is possible to
actually do this in a loop
we know the size of this array so it's a
10. and we can loop around 10 times
pretend each element at each iteration
and the way we do that we're going to
read with that loop and we're going to
say for
okay size t
and we're going to start from index to
zero this is really important because
arrays are indexed from zero they don't
start from one again this is something
you need to drill in your brain
and we're going to put in our test case
we're going to say i less than 10
because we want to go from 0 through 9
and we are going to increment our
iterator after we do that we're going to
have to
jump into the body of the loop and we
didn't name our iterator that's why
we're having this squiggly line here
let's do that pretty quick we're going
to jump into the body of our loop and we
are going to say sddc out
and we're going to say scores
and we need to be careful about how we
format this because i is not something
we have we're going to be getting that
from our iterator here so we're going to
print it like this and this is going to
work no big deal
and we're going to say
squares and we're going to say i that's
going to be our index that we want to
print the data for
and we're going to say stdendl
and uh because we don't want this to
confuse us
we're going to comment that out
and we're going to go up and make sure
our comment is nice and neat
and we're going to try and run this and
what do you expect to see
well we don't have any real data in here
we're going to have some junk data so it
could really be anything we get printed
here so let's build with gcc and we're
going to give ourselves some breathing
room we're going to go down and clear
and run rooster and you see that um this
is really some junk data and if we run
it again let's see that we get the same
output
it is the same data in here if we want
to have in some reliable data we need to
write in our own data and we're going to
see how we can do that we're going to
see how we can write data into an array
and the syntax is really simple so the
way you do that
you just say the index for which you
want to write data in and you say scores
and you specify the index let's say zero
and i'm going to put in a 20 for example
this is how you do this
you say 20 let's say scores
we're going to grab the index one the
first element and we're going to put in
a 21 why not
and we're going to say scores we're
going to say 2 for index 2 and we're
going to put in a 22
why not and after we do this we can
print this out or read data with the
loop and make sure that the data we did
writing is actually n
so we're going to copy this
and comment this out because we don't
want this to confuse us on the console
and we're going to do that we're going
to come down here and print the data out
let's say what we're doing here and if
we build this we expect to see
that at index 0 1 and 2 we have the
values 20 21 and 22.
let's build and see we're going to run
the test to build with gcc
the build is going to go through we're
going to clear and run the rooster
and look at this score is a 0 20 score
is 1 21 score is 2 22
and our data is actually getting gain
now we're going to see that we can also
write the data using the loop to make it
really easy without us manually doing
things like this
for that we're going to copy what we
have here to print data out
and we're going to comment what we had
out here
so let's comment this out and we're
going to go down
and uh print the data again we're going
to put in the code here and before we
print the data we're going to put data
in
with the loop so the loop is basically
going to be the same thing we're going
to say size
ti we're going to initialize this we're
going to say i less than 10 because we
want to loop 10 times we're going to
increment
and we're going to fall in the body of
the loop what we're going to do is write
data at the index of the current
iteration i should say so what we're
going to do we're going to say scores i
and we can really put in anything for
now let's say we want to put an i
multiplied by 10 so we're going to take
the current index multiply it by 10 and
we're going to store that in the index
at the current iteration this is what we
are doing here
and if we print this out try to think
about what we're going to get here
so
at index 0 let's put in a 0 to be super
clear here that we are starting from
index 0. at index 0 we're going to take
0 and multiply that with the 10 so we're
going to store 0 at index 0. the loop is
going to run again at index 1 we're
going to take a 1 multiply with 10 we're
going to get it 10 at index 2 we're
going to multiply 2 with a 10 and store
a 20 at index 2 and we're going to keep
going and basically have 0
10 20 all the way to 90 stored in our
array here so if we print it out we
expect to see 0 10 20 all the way to 90.
let's weld and see that that's actually
what we have in our array we're going to
work successfully let's clear and run
rooster and you see that this is exactly
the same thing we have in our array how
cool is that okay another thing i want
you to see is that we can declare and
initialize an array
in place but before we do that let's say
what we were doing here we were trying
to write data in a loop and we're going
to comment this out because we don't
want a lot of confusing output
in our console and we're going to go
down and put in the data because i don't
want to type all these thanks
so we can declare and initialize an
array in place and the way we do that
the array is going to store doubles now
we can really declare an array of
anything but so far we have seen that we
can do that for ant now let's try a
little bit and show you that you can do
the same thing for double times so we
can declare an array of double types the
size is going to be five and we're going
to initialize that with this data here
so at index zero we're going to have a
12.7 index one a 7.5 index 2 a 13.2
index 3
an 8.1 and index 4 and 9.3 and that's
what we're going to have if we print
this out here we have a simple loop to
print it out and it's going to basically
say salary 0
12.7 and it's going to go all the way to
salary 4 and print a 9.3 and this is
something you can do
if it makes sense for whatever you are
designing with c plus plus we're going
to build this with gcc
let's clear and run and you see that
this is exactly what we expect okay now
this is super clear the next thing we're
going to see is that if you don't
initialize all the elements in the array
those you leave out are going to be
initialized to zero and we are going to
put in a piece of code to play with that
so here we have an array it's a net
array it's going to be called families
and the size is going to be five but we
are only initializing three elements and
these elements are going to be elements
on the front so elements at index 3 and
4 are going to be left out and they are
going to be initialized to 0 by the
compiler so if we print this out we
expect to get 12 7 5 and 0 0 at
different indexes in this array here
let's build this
with gcc
we're going to clear because the build
is successful
and we're going to run this
this is exactly what we expect we have a
12 a 7 and 5 and the last two elements
are initialized to zero and this may
come in handy sometimes okay let's
comment this out another thing we want
to see is that we can actually
omit the size when we are declaring our
array
and initializing it so here is a simple
example we have an inter array called
class sizes we don't specify the size
but we initialize it and the compiler is
going to deduce the size of this array
from the elements we put in here so if
we put in two elements so it's going to
be of size 2 if we put in 10 elements
it's going to be of size 10 and this is
how this works but if you do something
like this and not to initialize the
array let's take this out for example
you're going to get a compiler error
because the compiler now doesn't know
which size it's going to give to this
array so be sure to
either
put in the size or initialize your array
like this and it is going to work in
this case we're going to have six
elements and and you see that a range
based for loop is going to come in handy
here because we don't really know the
size of this array if somebody comes and
adds another element let's say 23
the size is going to change and if we
hard to code the size in our full loop
the code is going to break but a range
based for loop is going to use whatever
size this already has so we're going to
try and build this we're going to build
with gcc as usual
and the world is going to go through if
we run rooster we're going to get the
elements we have 10 12 15 11 18 17 23 if
we add a new element this is going to
work
you see that we don't need to modify the
loop here to
put in the new size and this is really
cool i like this about range based for
loops we're going to build again
and we're going to clear
run the rooster and this is going to
give us exactly the data we have in the
array so this is one way you can do
things another thing we saw is that you
can't modify const arrays
so let's do an example here for example
we're going to grab this thing and uh
put an array declared down here we're
going to copy that and use that here and
we're going to make this cost
let's give it a name let's say
birds for example for example we want to
keep
track of
lines of birds or whatever this is just
an example to show you that you can't
modify this array so if you try to do
something like birds
and index 2 for example and you want to
change this to an 8
the compiler is going to complain you
see that visual studio code is
complaining already
expiration must be a modifiable value so
it is saying that the array stores const
elements so you can't modify elements of
this array okay so this is something you
can do if you don't want people to be
able to modify data in your array and
the last thing i'm going to show you is
that you can do operations on the data
in an array
so let's bring up our scores array again
so we're going to go up and copy it
because the code is using there so let's
put in our own scores array
it's going to be pretty fast and we're
going to say that it is an array with
this angle brackets we're going to
initialize this let's put in a bunch of
values and what we can do is sum these
things up we're going to store our
results in the sum variable and we're
going to loop around with a ranged based
for loop because we don't really know
the size of this array it can change any
time with however many elements and a
range based for loop is really cool in
that we don't have to keep track of the
size of ourselves
so we're going to go in here
and get each element
and add that to some
so for example for the first time sum is
going to be 0 because that's what we
initialize it with we're going to get
into this loop here the first element is
going to be 2 we're going to add that to
0 and get 2 we're going to add a 5 we're
going to get a 7 we're going to keep
adding this element and at the end sum
is going to contain the sum of all these
elements in the array here and this is
one cool way you can sum up the elements
in your array so if we run this we're
going to get the sun printed out let's
do that pretty quick we're going to run
this has to build with gcc and we have
ourselves a compiler error
what is happening here it's going to say
redeclaration of scores where did we
declare scores before let's go up and
make sure it is not declared somewhere
and it is declared here
so we want to comment this out
come back to our code so that we can see
it
and we're going to build again with gcc
and now the world is going through we're
going to clear
and if we run rooster
score
sum is 37 and if you sum these things up
i'm sure you get 37. this is really all
we set out to do in this lecture i hope
you have a better idea of how you can
declare your arrays put data in read
data out of those arrays make them const
or even do all kinds of operations on
them and this was really what this
lecture was all about
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
see a cool way we can use to get the
size of an array
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to see a way we can query for the
size of an array
at runtime if you remember in the last
lecture we had an example like this
showing how we can declare an array and
initialize it in a single statement like
this
but the problem we had with this is that
if we tried to print the array using a
for loop for example we would have to
use the size and the size of this array
may change if somebody decides to add
elements or remove elements then the
size is going to be irrelevant c plus
plus provides a way we can query for the
size of an array at runtime and we're
going to get the real size accounting
for the current number of elements that
we have in the array and for that we use
the std size function
this is a function that comes with the c
plus plus standard library so you're
going to have it already if you have a
compliant compiler if you see here you
see that it was introduced in c plus 17
and it is a cool addition we can use it
to make our code easier to work with if
you look here we have a simple loop
which is going to print data out it is
going to loop starting from zero all the
way to the size of the array you see
that we use this to control when this
loop is going to end we then put in our
incrementation part and then we jump
into the body of the loop and print the
current element in the loop and if we do
things like this we're going to be able
to print all elements in the array
regardless of the number we initialize
it with okay so this is one way and it
was introduced in c plus plus 17. but
some of you must be asking
how did we do things before z plus plus
well we had to kind of do a hack to get
something like this we use the size of
operator we have seen a lot of times
right now
and the way you use this
if you do size of and passing the array
you're going to get the entire size of
the array so if we take that and divide
that with the size of a single element
in the array we're going to get the
number of elements of the array and this
is really what we are doing here we are
setting up a count variable and we are
taking the size of the array and
dividing that with the size of a single
element in the array and we are just
grabbing the first element because you
can really use any element here and once
we have this we can use this count to do
a loop like this and it is working
pretty well
please remember that you don't have to
go through this craziness we're doing
here you don't even have to use std size
because you can use a ranged base for
loop and get access to the elements you
have in the array and it is going to
work pretty well now that you have an
idea about this let's head to visual
studio code and actually play with us
okay so here we are in our working
folder we are going to be working on
this project size of an array we're
going to grab our template project we're
going to copy the files and put them in
place
and we're going to open this up in
visual studio code let's do that it's
going to open up in visual studio code
and we're going to try and
clean it up a little bit and we are
going to declare an array if we want to
print this thing
we need to know how many times we're
going to loop and print elements in here
so one thing you might want to do is to
say okay we have 10 elements in here so
i'm going to loop for 10 times you might
think this is going to work and it is
going to work if we
bring up a terminal
and build this with gcc like we usually
do
and uh clear
and run rooster we are going to get our
numbers this is what we have in the
array from one to ten
but what if somebody comes and changes
the elements we have in here let's add
an 11 and a 12.
and
the moment we change this we will need
to come and change the size in here and
this loop here might be buried somewhere
deep in your project and it might not be
as easy as it is now to see that we also
need to change this this may be a really
big source of hard to debug problems so
what we really need is a way to get the
size of the array at runtime and be able
to dynamically query for that size and
use it in our program and that's exactly
what std size provides so we're going to
say end count
and we're going to put in a value let's
use a braced initializer so we're going
to say std size
and we're going to pass the array we
want to get the size for
and if we do this we're going to get
this size here
and we're going to be looping for this
number of times so we're going to test
for i is less than the count here
and now it doesn't matter how many
elements we have in here we're going to
get them at run time we need to only
update this initializer here so what we
can do is
weld with gcc again now
we're going to come here
and run rooster and we're going to get
the numbers here you see that we get all
the elements if we take out a few of
these elements let's take out a few of
these let's leave it up to seven or
eight
let's build again and we are going to
clear and run rooster we're going to get
however many elements we have in there
and this is pretty cool again you might
ask how did we do things before c plus
plus 17 because std size was introduced
in c plus plus 17 let's say that here
before that we had to get the size of
the entire array and divide that with
the size of each element in the array
and we could use the size of operator to
do that so before we do any of that we
want to play with the size of method to
really show you what it does
so what we're going to do is say sdd the
out size of
scores the entire array and we're going
to print that and we're going to say
sddcl
size of
you know one element let's say
scores and use the first element this is
the easiest thing we can find here but
you can use any element so we're going
to say size of here and we're going to
say scores and grab the first element
which is at index 0 and we're going to
print its size if we build and run this
program
we're going to build and run
and the world is good we can clear now
and run rooster you're going to see that
we're going to get size of scores is 32
the entire array the size of one element
is four because we are storing in
integers and i want you to see that 32
is four times eight because we have an
eight elements so it's going to give you
the combined size of all of the elements
that we have in here if you do size of
an array
but if you do size of a single element
you're going to get the size of a single
element so c plus plus developers were
clever enough to see this
and see that we could use this
information and get the count of
elements inside so we can do something
like ant account
and we're going to assign a value to
this
in our braced initializer so we're going
to say size
of
we're going to say scores
and we're going to divide that with size
of and i'm going to grab scores we can
really use any element in the array but
we're going to grab the one at index 0
and now we're going to get the count
stored in our account variable without
using std size and we can uncomment our
array here
or the code to print the array and if we
run now it is going to work exactly the
same thing regardless of the amount of
elements you have in here let's put a
few numbers randomly and if we will then
run we are going to clear and run
rooster and we're going to get all the
elements here and
you can really use any of these
techniques just choose what you feel
works better for you okay we are going
through all this trouble to set up an
iterator we're going to do the test
we're going to increment this is really
too much work to try and get data from a
collection like an array so what we can
do instead is comment out all this hard
work here
and we can use a ranged based for loop
as we have seen before and it is
ridiculously easy and convenient to work
with so what you can do is say for
auto i we're going to do
type deduction on whatever it is we have
stored in our array so we're going to
put a column and say scores
and we're going to print out the element
so let's do that we're going to print
stdcl and here we're going to say value
let's say value in the array and we're
going to say
i and this is going to print all the
elements and we can work with the values
inside if we want that but you see that
we have lost the information
on the indexes so if you really need the
indexes you will need to go through
something like this and if you just need
the values in the array ranged based for
loops are going to be really cool let's
say range base for loop and if we boiled
and run this it's going to work pretty
well
so the world is going to go through
let's bring this up so that we have some
breathing room we're going to clear
and run rooster
and we're going to get our elements
printed out here and you see that it is
the exact same thing we have in scores
here
so this is really all we set out to do
in this lecture i just wanted you to be
aware of the sdd size
facility that we have in the c plus plus
standard library if you don't want to
use it for any reason you can also go in
and do the division we did here to get
the count of elements in the array
and uh do your best to try and use
ranged basis for loops because they make
it easier and cleaner to get data from a
collection like we are doing here with
an array we are going to stop here in
this lecture and the next one we're
going to see how we can work with arrays
of characters
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to work on
array of characters and show how special
they are
you can declare an array of characters
just like any other array so here we
have
an array called message it stores
elements of type character the size is
five and we initialize it with a bunch
of characters
if we want to print it out we can look
like we loop through any other array in
this case we're going to be using a
ranged base for loop we say for auto c
we pass the message and then we're going
to be printing each character in the
message and if we do this we're going to
see hello printed out on the console we
can also modify elements in our array
for example we can say message1 and
change the e here to an a
and if we print out we should see hello
printed out on the console nothing
really special so far the cool thing you
can do with character arrays
is that you can print them to the
console directly without even doing the
loop you can do something like this you
can do sddc out you say whatever you
want to do in quotes here and you're
going to print the message but sometimes
this one to do what you expect because
only proper c strings can be printed on
the console and what makes up a proper c
string a proper c string has this thing
you see on the end here this backslash
zero
is called a null termination string and
it is what is going to tell c plus plus
that we have hit the end of the string
and we are going to stop printing it if
we are printing with things like stdcl
so this is really important to be in
your strength if it's not there it may
work but sometimes it's also going to
print some garbage characters after this
because what tells sddc out that we have
reached the end of the string is this
backslash zero here if it's not there
it's going to keep printing until it
sees one and then you're going to
probably have some garbage characters
added to your string and that's not what
you want so to have your strengths
printed out correctly be sure to have in
this null termination character here and
if we print it out we're going to get it
and we're going to see the size printed
out properly if we do things like this
but it is possible to get to this auto
field for us if you look here we have a
character array called message2 inside
we have said that we need six elements
and we say hello so we have one two
three four five elements and the
elements we don't initialize properly is
going to be initialized with a zero
version of a character and that happens
to be the null terminator of the null
termination character so this is going
to print correctly and we're going to
have the
backslash n appended to this for us by
the compiler but be sure you understand
the difference between this and this
here we have specified the size to be a
5 and we are putting in five elements so
we have no null character appended to
this string but here we have said that
we can put in six elements and we have
only put five and the compiler is going
to autofill then the null terminating
character these two things are different
and make sure you understand the
difference okay so now take a look at
what we have here we have a strand we
didn't specify the size and we just
initialize it with hello someone might
think ah this is also going to autofill
but it's not because the compiler is
going to deduce the size of this array
using what you initialize it with and
you didn't put in a null character so
it's not going to be accounted for
you're only going to have this here and
if you print this out you may get
garbage characters appended to your
string here so be careful but it is
possible to do literal c strings and
only say hello like this in quotes and
you're going to get the null terminating
character appended to your string here
so if we print this this is going to
pretty nicely and this is the
recommended way to initialize your
character arrays if you want to put in
string data like this you have to use
double quotes and the cool thing about
this is that you can even put in
spaces between words like this it is
going to work this really looks like how
you would like to type text and store
that in your character arrays and we're
going to be using this a lot in the
course again i want to bring to your
attention that character arrays are
special
in that you can directly print them on
the console
like we are doing here you see this is a
character array and we are saying stdc
out message for you can't do this with
other arrays and this is really all i
had to share about character arrays so
what we're going to do next is head to
visual studio code and play with us okay
here we are in our working directory the
current project is arrays of characters
we're going to grab our template project
and we're going to copy the files
bring them in here
and we are going to open our folder
we're going to open the main cpp file
and we're going to get rid of what we
don't need here let's put in some
startup code so that we can start
playing with this without typing this
too much so we're going to declare an
array of characters it's going to be
called message the size is going to be
five and we're going to fill it with
characters like this so if we do this we
might want to print it like we print any
other array we're going to use loops and
in this case we chose to use
a range base for loop so we take a toast
c c for character
in message and we're going to print out
each character notice that we're not
adding std endl here because we want the
characters printed close to each other
so that we can read this easily and
after this we will need to go to the
next line so that the next thing we
print doesn't disturb us so we're going
to say sddc out std endl and if we do
this we're going to see hello printed
out on the console but we had to do too
much work to print something simple
like hello but let's do this we are
learning
so we're going to bring up our terminal
and we're going to build with gcc let's
do that
the world is going to go through and
we're going to clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
it's going to say message is hello and
this is what we expect and this is
really how you would declare an array of
characters and initialize it with
whatever it is you want to initialize it
with but you notice that it's really not
convenient to put data in here if you
want to store a message for example for
someone you don't want to do this thing
you see here it's really ugly it's
convenient and nobody would definitely
use your program if you required your
users to type things like this so we
need to change this and we will but
before we get there let's also see that
we can change characters in our array so
if you look here this e here is at index
two so what we can say is a message and
uh we're going to target the element on
index
two oh it's index one
let's use that so this is index zero the
h and the e is at index one let's make
sure we get this straight and we're
going to store in an a
in quotes remember characters are
surrounded by single quotes like this
once we do this and we try to print the
array out again using our
technique here we're going to copy the
code and we're going to paste it down
here
just to do this simply
and if we do this we're going to see the
message printed out here to be hello
and the second message is going to be
hello with an a
because we changed the second element
to an a it's no longer an e so that's
what we expect we're going to run the
test to build with gcc and we're going
to bring this up and clear and we're
going to run rooster you see that we
have message hello and message hello and
we are able to print things successfully
this is really cool but we are doing too
much work really to print something on
the console and there should be an
easier way to do this and there is so
what we're going to do is comment this
out because we don't want noise output
in the console when we try to do
something else
so what we're going to do is comment out
all we've done so far we're going to
leave in our message here and we're
going to try and print it directly on
the console so we can say sddcl
and say message
and we're going to print out the message
and take a moment and look at this
and try to compile this it is going to
go through it is going to compile
because c plus plus
supports printing character arrays like
this
but uh
in most times this is not going to do
what you expect let's try and run this
and see what we get
we're going to run rooster
and you see that
we're lucky to get something that really
isn't what we expect
it's pretty hello and you see that we
have a bunch of other things and the
reason is what we have discussed in
these slides for character arrays like
this to be printed out properly
on the console they need to be null
terminated in other words they need to
have the null character which is a
backslash zero appended to the string
for sddc out to know that it has reached
the end of the string so this is what
makes your character strings legal
now you see that we are getting a
compiler error because we have overflown
the size of the array i think that's the
message too many initializer values and
this is exactly what we have done
now we can try and change this guy to a
six to say that we have six elements in
here
this wiggly line should go away and if
we try to build and run
we're going to build with gcc
let's bring this up a little bit and
we're going to clear
and run rooster now
and you see that now we have hello
printed out correctly if we turn this
back to five elements
and take out the null terminator
we're going to try and build again and
we're going to clear and run rooster
you're going to see that we get the
garbage back so for your strings to be
printed out correctly they need to be
now terminated that's why it is not safe
to prank something like this
when your character array is not now
terminated i really want you to
understand this so in c plus plus we
have a proper name for these strings
that are null terminated a null
terminated string is called the c string
because these things come from the c
programming language okay and we're
going to see a few ways we can set up c
strings now and the first one is to say
car we can call this message one
and it's going to be an array of
characters and we're going to initialize
this with hello let's copy this because
i don't want to type all these
things here so let's copy this
and initialize this properly notice that
we didn't specify the size so the
compiler is going to get the size from
however many elements we put in here and
we're going to put in our null
terminator here and if we print this
this is going to work and we are going
to comment this out and i'm going to say
that this will give you garbage okay if
we come down here we're going to see
that we have a car array it is called
message1 and we have initialized it with
data we have hello and we have a null
terminator here and the compiler is
going to deduce the size so this is
going to be a proper c string and we
will print it correctly
let's try and weld this the board is
going to go through if we clear and run
rooster we're going to get our message
here and this is one way we can set up a
proper c string the second way is to
actually not putting the null terminator
but let the compiler add that in for you
and the way we can do that we can say
car message to and we're going to say
this array is of size 6. let's say that
we're going to put in a six
and a fix how we end things here we're
going to put in our code
and end this with a semicolon now what
is going to happen is the compiler is
going to see that this array is of size
6 but we are putting in five elements so
the remaining slots are going to be auto
filled and it is going to be using
null terminators to autofill this then
if we try to print the size here we're
going to get a
because the null terminator is added in
by the compiler let's try and print the
sizes here actually so that you can see
these things so we're going to say size
and we're going to say that size of
message one and we're going to put in a
new line character and this should be
what we expect so what we're going to do
we're going to copy this
and i put that down here because we're
going to be doing the same thing for
message to so we're going to say message
to let's select this
and i say size of message to and do
signs of message too so what we're going
to see is a message 1 and message 2
printing out and we expect to see a size
of 6 because both of these guys have six
elements inside so we're going to run
the task to build with gcc
and bring this up clear
rooster
and this is exactly what we expect
message one is hello the size is six
message two is hello and the size is six
and these are a few ways you can declare
your character arrays and initialize
them with proper data that is going to
print correctly with stdc out make sure
you don't do something like we did here
by printing message here because it is
not null terminated this is going to
give you a lot of problems again i want
to make it really clear
that message three here is not a proper
c string because the compiler is going
to deduce however many elements we have
in here and this thing is going to be of
size five
and we're not going to have a null
terminator and if we print it out we're
going to get some garbage so let's try
and copy this so that we are consistent
with
what we've done above here and if we
compile with gcc
we are going to compile successfully but
we may get weird things if we print out
message three like we do here and you're
going to see that the size is five
because we only have five elements in
here so let's clear and run rooster and
you're going to see that
we have hello for message one we have
hello for message two but for message
three we have things we don't expect
because it's going to keep printing and
it's going to go overbound and it's
going to stop when it hits the first
no terminating character
like what we have in here okay so this
is not safe don't do it make sure your
strengths are null
it if you intend to print them with sddc
out like this okay so working with
character arrays like this to print
messages and do all kinds of crazy
things is nice but it really isn't
convenient as i said before
you wouldn't expect your users to type
characters like this by surrounding them
with single quotes this is really ugly
and it is painful to do if you want to
do some productive work so c plus plus
allows you to use what we call string
literals and we're going to see an
example of that
down below we're going to say string
literals and uh what we can do is car
message for it's going to be an array as
usual
and we can initialize it
with a string that is surrounded by
double quotes and what this is going to
tell c plus plus
is you know take these things break it
into characters and store this in this
array here and make sure you properly
now terminate this string here so if we
print the size of message four we're not
going to get five we're going to get six
because c plus plus is going to see
these double quotes and know that we
intend for these things to be properly
null terminated and it's going to add a
null terminator so let's try and print
this out so that we really are sure and
we're going to weld this with gcc as we
always do
the world is going to go through let's
go up and clear and we're going to run
rooster
and you see that message 4 is hello
and the size is indeed a sex
so this is one way we have to do things
and we can even put spaces
and do all kinds of crazy things and
it's really cool and if we try to build
this we're going to get the proper
message printed out you see the world is
good if we clear and run rooster we're
going to see hello world how are you
doing and this is really cool so from
now on if we need to store a string in
our program this is how we're going to
do it because this is much more
civilized and it is how you would really
like to type characters in your program
i have said that character arrays are
really special because you can directly
print them out with stdc out like this i
want to prove this so we're going to try
and declare another array so we're going
to call this numbers
and we're going to make this an array
and we're going to initialize with one
two three four five this is going to do
and we're going to put our closing
semicolon and we're going to try and
print this out i'm going to say std
see out and say numbers
let's see what we get
let's try and compile this and see what
we get it is not actually going to give
us a compiler error but it's not going
to print what we expect and let's put a
message here so that we know that it is
this thing we are seeing here so we're
going to say numbers and we're going to
put a column here
and we're going to weld this
with gcc
and we're going to clear
and if a run rooster look out for the
output that says numbers here so let's
run rooster it's not a one two three
four five it's something we don't really
know
and we will get to understand what is
happening here
in the next chapter for now note that
you can't directly print arrays other
than those of characters if you try to
do that you're going to get weird
numbers printed out and we're going to
understand why this is
the next chapter so let's say that here
okay this is really all we set out to do
in this lecture i hope you found it
interesting character arrays have a few
things you need to be careful about and
we try to cover those in this lecture we
are going to stop here in this lecture
and the next one we're going to try and
look at array bounds
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
look at what could happen if you try to
manipulate data out of the bounds of
your array we have seen that when you
allocate space for an array the computer
is going to give you a bunch of memory
locations you can use to store your data
and it's going to be of the size that
you have specified or that is deduced by
the compiler so here is an example of an
array that is going to store seven
elements and we have green slots for
these elements and these are the
locations we are allowed to manipulate
in our c plus plus program if we try to
go overbound for example if we try to
modify something before our array or
after our array
it might be a memory location that is
owned by another program it might be a
memory location that is even being used
by the operating system so bad things
can really happen if you try to use data
that is outside the bounds of your array
let's try to look at a simple example
here here we have an array called
numbers we have 10 slots inside so we
are only allowed to modify the memory
locations for these 10 numbers and if we
try to access something outside the
bounds of this array something might
happen but some people say that c plus
plus is really funny because it should
be stopping you from doing something
like this but c plus plus allows you to
do this if you look at code here we have
an array we have 10 elements n so the
valid indexes we can really use are from
0 to 9. but if we try and access
something at index 12 the code is going
to compile and if we run it we're going
to get something printed out but that's
something this is going to give you
garbage data or you might be even trying
to read some restricted memory and your
program is going to terminate
immediately and we're going to say that
it has crashed if you try to write over
bounce the compiler is also going to
allow it but you don't own the memory so
other programs might come and change
that memory location and if you try to
read from it again you're not going to
get what you expect another thing that
could happen is that you try and modify
data that is owned by other programs and
you might imagine how bad that really is
so the message here is don't go over
your array balance and you're going to
be playing in the safe zone let's head
over to visual studio code and play with
us a little bit here we are in our
working directory the current project is
array balance we're going to grab the
template files
and we're going to
put them in place
and we're going to open this up in
visual studio code we are going to
declare an array and try to read beyond
the legal bounds of our array so let's
try and bring up a terminal here and we
are going to build this with gcc the
world is going to go through you're not
going to get a compiler error but if we
run this we can really get anything and
you see we have a number we don't really
know what it means and this means that
you have read
out of the legal bounds of your array
and c plus plus
allows you to do this and the reason
they do this is because they expect you
the developer to know what you're doing
when you try manipulating things like
ray and now you know this and be careful
when you are working with arrays like
this so don't go overbound that's the
message we may also try to modify data
beyond balance so let's go down and put
in the code to modify thanks and i have
put a clear message here as a comment to
let you know that this is really
something you should be very very
careful about so we're going to try and
change that number to 1000 and we're
going to try and print it out and see
what we get but this memory location at
index 12
is not something we own so other
programs might come and write to this
location and if we try to read from it
again we might not get what we put in
here even worse this memory location
might be owned by other programs and if
they read they're going to get what they
didn't put in they're going to get what
you put in and this is something bad we
might try and really go crazy with us
let's put in a really huge number and
see that we can do that
this is a good way to learn by the way
it's going to compile
and let's try and print what we have in
there and we're going to say
this location here
and that's what we're going to say here
and we're going to build again the world
is going to go through you see that we
are doing something really crazy our
array has 10 elements but we are trying
to modify something
1 million memory locations away and uh
this is really crazy and c plus plus
allows you to do this
so let's clear and run did we world
let's make sure we have world so let's
build with gcc
and clear
and run rooster our program is crashing
because we are trying to access
something
that isn't really ours and you see it
has crashed
okay for example if we have something
printed out after this let's say std
program
and then so that you can see it is
really crashing
and say stdndl
this statement here is not going to
print because once we hit this location
we're going to try and modify this and
the program is not going to be able to
do that it's going to crash the
operating system is going to notice that
we are trying to do something crazy and
it's going to say this program is really
crazy it doesn't know what it's doing i
am going to kill it and it is going to
stop that's basically what is happening
here so let's weld again with gcc
and we're going to clear
let's clear
and run rooster you see that it's going
to try and do this it's going to try and
put a value in here the program is going
to end here and this is really bad
because memory locations you have
allocated for before here are not
properly released and returned to the
operating system and this is something
really bad so the message is
don't go overbound make sure you are
working within the legal boundaries of
your array welcome to this new chapter
and we are going to be talking about
pointers pointers are one of the
important topics in c plus plus and they
allow you to do some of the things very
conveniently and we're going to be
learning about all those tricky things
you can do with them in this chapter but
now i want you to have a basic
understanding of what a pointer really
is
so far we have been working with
variables like this we set up a variable
in our c plus plus code we get to a
point where we put a value inside that
variable and we could use it for example
we could print it out on stdc out or we
could even store a value or assign
another value to the variable we've been
doing that quite a lot but there is a
point we haven't really been talking
about those variables have an address in
memory and here for example you see that
our var
is stored at location one zero zero
eight of course this is a simple example
i came up with
but i hope it drives the point home all
the variables you use in your code have
some kind of address in memory
and we can grab that address and store
that in a special kind of variable which
is really a pointer so we can say that a
pointer
is a special kind of variable
that stores addresses of other variables
make sure you really understand this
here we have p var so it is a pointer
its type is end pointer and we denote
pointer using this star symbol after our
type if you see something like this
you're going to know that this type is a
pointer to end its name is going to be p
var because it's a variable
and its value is going to be the address
of another variable you see it is
storing 1 0 0 8 which happens to be the
address of our var here in memory
pointers and variables we've been
talking about can work hand in hand and
we're going to be seeing how this is
done in the next few lectures in the
chapter but the basic idea is really the
same here you see that we have a pointer
to it but you can have a pointer ready
to anything in your code you can have a
pointer to car you can have a pointer to
double you can have a pointer to float
even pointers to custom types we haven't
really talked about now but we will
learn about them later in the course
again a pointer is a special type of
variable in your c plus program that is
going to store addresses to other
variables that's what it really is and
we're going to start and see how you can
declare initialize and use them in your
code starting in the next lecture
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to see how
we can declare and use pointers in our c
plus plus code in the last lecture we
say that a pointer is a special kind of
variable
that can store addresses to other
variables in our c plus plus code and we
have seen a slide like this to drive the
point home now we're going to see how we
can actually use pointers in our code
here is a simple example of how you can
declare a pointer variable in your c
plus plus code you say ent you put a
star after the type
to mean that this variable is not a
regular variable like we have seen
before it is a special kind of variable
that is going to store
addresses to other variables and here i
have to say that you have to be really
careful and only store addresses to
value the types of variable
in your pointers for example this is a
pointer to end it can only store an
address of a variable of type and for
other types if you try and put in their
addresses in here you're going to get a
compiler error down here you see we have
another example and it's called p
fractional number because it's a double
and you see that our pointers here are
initialized using braced initializers
and this is going to initialize the
pointers with a special address that
really denotes that these pointers are
not pointing to anything yet okay you
can also say that explicitly and put now
ptr inside and this is going to mean
that these pointers are not pointing
anywhere you can't really use the values
at the addresses where they point this
is the message here don't use pointers
that contain null pointer all pointers
on a given system are going to have the
same size for example if you have a
pointer to end and the pointer to double
they are going to be the same size
because they really store the same thing
they store addresses to variables and
addresses to different variables even if
they happen to be of the same type on
the same system are of the same size
that's why all the pointers you're going
to use in your code are going to have
the same size and this is something you
should keep in mind and here is a simple
example to really play with that we have
a size of it printed out we have a size
of our pointers printed out and we're
going to compare these things when we
get to visual studio code in a minute
and you're going to see that all
pointers are of the same size a question
i get from many people is if the
position of this star symbol
really matters and i have to break it to
you it doesn't but i prefer to put it on
the left some people prefer to put it on
the right but definitely don't put it in
the middle i've never seen anybody do
this but it's going to work it's going
to be legal c plus plus code another
thing i see people do which is really
confusing is to declare your pointers on
the same line and do a comma like this
this is really going to be confusing and
now i want you to guess and see what is
happening here is either it var a
pointer or it's a regular end i want you
to keep this in mind i'm not going to
tell you we're going to try this out
actually in visual studio code and we're
going to figure this out together but
now i want you to try and think about it
we're going to leave this question
unanswered and we're going to answer it
in a little while but for now
don't really do this because it's
confusing and it's going to make your
code less readable if you have to do
something like this make sure you just
put them on different lines and it's not
going to be confusing for example if you
look down here you're going to know that
p number seven is a pointer other
interval is a regular end and there is
no room for confusion this time use code
like this and don't put things on the
same line like we have on top here okay
now we have seen that we can declare and
initialize pointers with null pointer
now is the time to see how we can put
actual data in those pointer variables
here we have a variable which is called
into var it is of type and and its value
is a 43
we can also set up another pointer
variable end pointer
its name is p
underscore int and we can initialize it
with the address of another variable and
here is a new operator we haven't seen
before this ampersand variable here
really means the address of this ant
variable that's what we mean here so
we're going to initialize this p end
variable with the address of enter
variable and this is how we do it
if we go down here we print antivirus
we're going to get the value printed
down if we print the pointer directly
we're going to get the address of this
little guy printed out on the console
and we're going to see it okay so this
is how you can store things in your
pointer variables and what you have to
store and has to be an address of
another variable
down here you see we have another
variable called into r1 inside we have a
65 and if you go down here you see that
we are storing something else
in our point of variable here we had in
the address of into var now we are
putting in the address of into var1
using an assignment operator and this is
something you can definitely do it's
legal c plus plus it's going to work if
we print it out we're going to get a
different address printed out this is
how you can store values in your pointer
variables again you can't cross a sign
before different pointer types here we
have an eight pointer which is called
pn1 and we have a double variable it's
called double var we can't take the
address of double var and store that in
pnt1 this is going to be a compiler
error the variables whose addresses you
store in payment 1 have to be of type
and again the basic idea is that a
pointer is really a special kind of
variable that is going to store
addresses to other variables and if your
pointer is a pointer to end
the variables whose addresses you can
store in this pointer to end can only be
ends if you try and put in doubles
you're going to be in trouble you're
going to get a compiler error and it's
not going to work now we're going to
head over to visual studio code and
actually play with these things here we
are in our working directory the current
chapter is pointers the current lecture
is declaring and using pointers we're
going to grab our template files and put
them in place
so put them in our project here and
we're going to open this in visual
studio code the first thing we're going
to see is how we can declare
and initialize pointers and we're going
to use a pointer to end as a first
example we're going to set up an inch
pointer and we say in store we're going
to give it a name we're going to call
this p number and you can leave it like
this uninitialized but it is really
advised to always initialize your
pointers so we're going to do that with
a brist initializer which is going to do
that for us this is going to implicitly
initialize it with zero equivalent of
pointers and that happens to be null
pointer so we'll initialize okay so this
is what we're going to initialize with
no
pointer we say no ptr
and this is how you should do things you
can also do a pointer to double why not
let's do double pointer and we're going
to say fractional number pointer to
fractional number and we can also
initialize this with null pointer
implicitly
and
once you do this the program is going to
be legal if we try to world at with gcc
like we always do the build is going to
be good but we don't really have any
useful thing we can see
if we run this program we are just
getting started we will get to see
things later for now just understand
that p number is a variable we have in
our code this variable can only store
addresses to other variables that happen
to be of type and if you try and store
in an address of a variable which is of
type double for example or flute you're
going to get a compiler error you
shouldn't do that the same for p
fractional number it can only store
addresses to other variables which
happen to be of type double keep this in
mind we can also
explicitly initialize with no pointer so
we can say end pointer and say p number
one why not and we're going to
explicitly use no
ptr like this and this is going to work
as well you can also say
p fractional number and say
one why not and say now pqr this is
going to work this is something you can
do you're going to see that if we
compile this the compiler is going to be
happy with this the world is good okay
now you know how you can declare and
initialize your pointers now we want to
see
that pointers to different variables are
actually of the same size
on whatever system you are working on
it's not consistent across operating
systems or riffing systems but it is
guaranteed to be of the same size on the
same machine
i am going to go down and put in a piece
of code that is going to show us all
these things on the console and i am
going to click on this file icon here
and give ourselves
some breathing room so that we can see
the entire thing here if you look here
we are printing the size of ant we know
that this is going to be a four
size of double this is going to be an
eight on our system here but we don't
know what the size of a double pointer
is or the size of an end pointer and
we're going to see that in a minute here
you see that we are also using the
pointer variables immediately this is
something you can do you see that visual
studio code is not complaining and we
can go on top here and boulder with gcc
let's do that
the world is going to be good now we can
open up a terminal and actually run this
program here we're going to clear if we
do there
we're going to see that
in
our directory here so you see that we
have rooster.exe
and we can run this and it's going to
say
sizeofant is four size of double is
eight
this is expected but pointer types are
of size 8 on my system they occupy 8
bytes in memory so it doesn't matter the
type we are pointing to a pointer to it
is always going to be 8 bytes in memory
this is something you should really know
and keep in your mind another thing we
have said that i want to play with right
now
is the location of the star symbol some
people say you should put it on the left
some people say you should put it to the
right i don't really think any of these
dense matters i prefer to put it to the
left but if you put it to the right it's
also possible it's going to work you see
that even if you put it in the middle
here which is really crazy the compiler
is going to take this we can run the
task to build this to make sure the
compiler is really happy and you see
that there's no problem the compiler is
going to accept this and we are going to
build successfully if you put your
declaration on a single line like this
what is other ant var going to be is it
going to be a regular end variable is it
going to be a pointer to end
we don't really know now and i don't
want to tell you we're going to find out
together so what we're going to do we're
going to print the size of these things
i am going to go down here and put in
the code and come back in a minute here
is our code typed out and we're going to
see the size of these things what we're
going to do is run the task to build
with gcc as we always do let's clear
properly
and run rooster
and you see size of p number five is
eight
because it's a pointer size of either
end is four and the same applies to the
second line here
so from this we can tell that other
interval and other ant versus x are not
pointers they are regular integers and
this can be really confusing so to avoid
this confusion i would advise not to
declare
your thanks when you have pointers
inside like this because that's going to
be really confusing what you can do is
put them on separate lines and do
something like this so here it is very
clear that p number seven is a pointer
other eight var seven is a regular it
variable and there is no room for
confusion with this way of doing that so
make sure you put things on separate
lines like this and you're going to be
fine now what i want you to see is that
we can actually store data in all
pointers i mean valid data that is not
null pointer in this case we're going to
set up a variable a regular end variable
it's going to store a 43 inside and
we're going to set up another pointer
and initialize that with the address of
this it variable and this is going to
work properly what we can do now
is print the interval we're going to
print it out if we try to print the
pointer we're going to get the address
of this into var in memory and this is
something you need to see with your eyes
this is the first time we are printing
out an address that is stored in a
pointer and we're going to see that on
the console here what i am going to do
before we build and run this i am going
to comment out everything we've done
before because our console is now
cluttered
so let's come and comment out everything
and let's go down again now if we print
we're going to see these two statements
and that's going to be easier to follow
on the console here the build is good so
we are cool
let's run rooster
and the var is 43 and its address in
memory is this number here it is in
hexadecimal so this is the address in
memory and we can print that out and see
what it is okay so this is really cool
but we can also change what is stored in
our pointer here for example we can set
up another variable call it into our one
and uh change pnt which is a pointer to
contain the address of this new variable
and we can do that now if we print
payment we're going to see that it
contains a different address and we can
do that
so let's build with gcc again
we're going to go down and clear and run
rooster and we're going to see that now
we have a different address the one we
had ended in d e4 now we end in de0
these are different addresses and we are
storing different things in our pointer
this is really cool you can do something
like this and the next thing we want to
see now is that we can't cross a sign
between pointers of different types and
what i mean here is that for example if
we have two variables here one is a
pointer to end it is initialized with no
pointer and we have another variable
which is a double var it's going to be
of type double
and we can't do something like payment
equals address of double bar you can't
do something like this if you do it
you're going to get a compiler error and
you see that we have squiggly lines
in visual studio code this is a good
indication that something might be wrong
if we open the problems tab we're going
to say a value of double pointer cannot
be assigned to an entity of type 8
pointer so this is not something you can
do if you do this you're going to get a
compiler error be aware of this visual
studio code has warned us enough but we
can also try and get
a clear compiler error by building this
with gcc and we're going to get
basically the same thing you can't
cross-assign between pointers of
different types we are trying to assign
a double address
into a pointer to enter and this is not
going to work so let's comment this out
because we don't want this compiler
error now you know this and before we
close this lecture i want to mention
what is called the referencing and that
is the act of reading something
through a pointer so if we have an
address in a pointer we can go through
that address and actually read the value
contained in that address and we can do
something like this so if we have for
example an end pointer let's call it p
and two do we have a variable like this
so let's say we initialize this with
nodepointer and we have an end
variable and this is a 56 for example
and we do something like we do say
pnt2 we're going to make it contain the
address of int data this is something
you know you can do now now we want to
go through pm to 2 to read what is
contained in interdata because pn 2
contains the address of our integer here
so what we can do we can do stdc out and
say value and the syntax we use in c
plus plus is like this we say store and
we say our pointer variable we're going
to say pnt2 and now if we run we're
going to get the value here printed out
okay now if we try to build we're going
to build fine let's try with gcc
the world is good
we can clear
so that the arrows from
a previous run are cleared out
you see the bullet is good we can now
run rooster
and we're going to see that value is 56
we are successfully
reading the value stored in the address
pointed to by our pointer here and this
is the syntax used and this is called
the referencing a pointer we are
basically reading something stored in
the address of a pointer this is what we
mean here this is really all we set out
to do in this lecture the lecture turned
out to be lengthy but we had a lot of
ground to cover and now i hope you have
a good grasp on how to declare
initialize and use your pointers to do
all kinds of crazy things
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
learn a little more about pointer to
character types because they are also
special
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
explore pointer to characters
and you can declare a pointer to a
character just like this we have car
pointer
and we say p carvar to give it a
variable name we initialize this with a
null pointer and after that we set up a
character variable and it is called
corvar and we store in an a in uppercase
a after that we take the address of car
of r and assign that to our pointer
variable this is how we store data in a
pointer and we can go through this
pointer to access data in this character
variable if we do something like this
we're going to print a down here we
declare another variable we store in a c
and we
assign the address of this new character
variable to our pointer variable and if
we print this again we're going to get a
c printed out this is really what we
have done in the last lecture we are
just extending that to character
pointers but with character pointers you
can do something really special what you
can do that is special you can
initialize that with a string literal
something like hello world which is
wrapped in quotes like this when you do
something like this the string here is
going to be expanded into a character
array and the first character of our
array is going to be pointed to by p
message here this is what we mean i
realize i might be throwing a lot of
things at you right now i am mixing up
arrays and pointers but they have a
really strong relationship and we're
going to learn about that in detail in a
few lectures ahead but for now
think of it like this this hello world
string is going to be turned into a
character array and the p message is
going to point to the first character
in this array here this is what is going
to happen and this is going to give us
the flexibility of treating our
strengths as character pointers and this
is going to come in handy at many
occasions
one thing i should tell you though is
that some compilers will refuse to
compile this code for example visual
studio 19 that i have installed on my
computer right now is going to refuse to
compile this code and the reason is the
compiler is going to expand this
strength into
a character array of const car
and here what we are using to point to
that is not a cost car pointer
so this pointer here can be used to try
and modify data into an array of cost
cars and that's going to be disastrous
because if you try to modify that
that's going to fail and that's not
going to be good so some compilers are
going to try and protect you from this
and force you to use pointers that are
qualified with cost to really mean that
they are closed car pointers and to get
the code to work we will have to do that
and i will show you how we do that in
visual studio code but i have to tell
you this in case you just want to jump
ahead and try this code out if you get a
compiler error that's going to be the
reason now that we have our strength
stored in memory we can really print it
out like this if you print p message
you're going to get this ring printed
out but i want to give you a question
here
what do you think we will get if we
dereference p message
try to think about this
i told you that the compiler is going to
expand this hello world string into an
array of characters or to be specific an
array of const cards
and p message is going to be pointing to
the first character
in that array
so if we dereference p message we're
going to get that character printed out
in this case we will get an h and that's
what is going to happen here but
character pointers are special in that
if you print them out directory the
compiler is going to do its magic and
make it possible to print out the entire
string that is stored in p message here
that's how character pointers are
special and you really need to be aware
of this because this is going to come in
handy many times just to emphasize that
this is going to be expanded into an
array of constant characters if we try
to modify
something inside p message here for
example we try to change the h into a b
we can try to do that because p message
is pointing to the first character so we
can try to dereference and assign a new
value and if we do that we're going to
get a compiler arrow or even worse we
might get a crash at run time so this is
something you shouldn't really do and
you should really flag
your p message here as the cost card
pointer and that's going to prevent you
from doing things like this which may
turn out to be very bad but most
compilers are going to even prevent you
from compiling this thing in modern
times for example if you are using a
very recent version
of visual studio you're going to get a
compiler error but i don't believe gcc
is going to give us a compiler error so
we will have to try this out and see how
it behaves but the message is if you
have to do something like this make sure
you use the cost car pointer and you're
going to be playing on the safe side
okay now i think you know enough about
character pointers what if we want our
users to be able to change this string
and make it be something else for
example change the first character here
into a b well in that case don't use
character pointers use regular arrays
like we have seen before so you can set
up an array like this it's going to be a
character array and you can initialize
it with the string literal and this is
going to allow you to modify things
inside so if we do something like this
we will get the message printed out and
the message is going to be tailored
because we changed the edge to be
a t and this is going to work so this is
something you really need to be aware of
but character pointers are very helpful
in many cases and in most cases you just
want to store the string and print it
out you're not interested in changing it
so that's why this is going to come in
handy in a lot of occasions now that you
know this we're going to head over to
visual studio code and actually try this
out okay here we are in our working
folder the current project is pointer to
car that's what we are exploring here so
we're going to grab our template files
and put them in place and we are going
to open this thing into visual studio
code and we're going to jump into here
and set up our first const car pointer
let's do a car pointer to see how this
thing behaves we're going to call this
message and we're going to initialize
this with our trusty message here hello
world okay once you do something like
this your string is going to be referred
to
by message let's try and compile this
and see that gcc is happy we can compile
with gcc
and uh it's going to tell us we can't
really do that and this is really good
for base converting a string to constant
card pointer so what we are doing really
is making an array of const characters
and refer to it as a car pointer and
this is not going to work this is a good
thing so you can't really do this and
this is a good thing
and let's try and see if visual studio
can actually do this we're going to
build with msvc in this case let's do
read to rooster before we do that we can
right click to add and say delete
let's click to it first
make sure it is selected and hit delete
to remove it
move to recycle bin in this case
now we're going to clear here let's
bring up our terminal again
and we're going to clear
and we're going to build with gcc
we're going to choose the msvc compiler
if you're trying to build this
world finish it
with errors and the error is going to be
basically the same thing this line here
won't work what we can do is make this
cost and make it super clear
that message here is going to point to
an array of const car
if we try to build again i think we're
going to be good now so let's try and do
that
we're going to build with msvc this time
and world finished successfully
now this is really cool and we can print
this out we can say sddc out
message
and we're going to say message
and this is going to work
let's go back to gcc because that's my
favorite compiler and you see that the
compiler from visual studio is going to
clutter our folder here with a lot of
files
we don't want that what i'm going to do
i'm going to select all this collector
here and remove that and i'm going to
hit delete with the right click
and it's going to go away
we're going to go back to gcc and use it
and build with gcc
the build is going to go through because
we qualified our character pointer with
cost here and everything is going to be
good be sure
you know what is happening here because
this kind of problems can be really hard
to solve okay now that we have this we
can try and change something inside but
the compiler is not going to allow it so
if we try and do something like this is
not going to work because message is a
pointer to closed car
and we can't go through this pointer to
modify something so we're going to get a
compiler arrow this is something you
should know but we can add the reference
this pointer and print something that is
inside and i want you to guess again and
see that you can come up with what is
going to be printed if with the
reference message and print out when we
run this program if we have this thing
printed out here again we are the
referencing the pointer
and printing whatever result we get from
that remember that this string literal
is going to be turned into an array of
const cars and the first element of that
array is going to be pointed to
by this message car pointer here so if
we dereference this thing we should get
the h here printed out that's what i
think we should get
let's try and bolt
with gcc of course
the bolt is going to be good let's clear
and run rooster
see that message is h this is exactly
what we expect here now that we have
this working
what if we really want this thing here
to work what if we wanted to allow our
users to go through
this message thing and modify what is
stored inside because sometimes that's
going to be
useful okay we wanted to allow our users
to modify this trend if you want to do
that you can use row character arrays
and the way we do that we can say car
message one and we can make it an array
and initialize that with hello world and
once we do this we can go through the
angle bracket syntax and modify the
first character or whatever character we
really want to modify in this string
here in this case we are going to target
the first so we're going to say message
1 and we're going to grab the index 0
because that's going to be the first
character here and we're going to assign
a new character let's say
b like we just said and if we print this
out say message one and uh put that out
we're going to see what comes out if we
run this program we're going to build
with gcc
so let's do that
the world is good so we're good here
if we're on we're going to get below
printed down and we have successfully
changed this thing here so if you don't
want to allow modifications to your
strength use this thing here if you want
to allow modification to your strength
use this syntax here and this is really
all we had to say
in this lecture in this lecture we're
going to revisit our idea of a c plus
plus program
memory map we have seen that the c plus
plus development workflow really goes
like this we have a program typed out in
our ide we pass that through the
compiler and we get a binary executable
which is a binary representation of the
code we have in our c plus plus program
you can then run that program on an
operating system for example here i am
on windows if i double click on my dot
exe file for example our applications
are called
rooster.exe you've seen me run this a
thousand times by now
if we double click this program is going
to be loaded in our computer memory and
by memory i mean random access memory
the memory that is going to be actively
running things when they happen in your
computer is different from the hard
drive
storage that can also be called memory
and this can throw off a lot of
beginners we are talking about ram here
when we mean memory random access memory
to be exact if you double click on your
program or open it on the terminal like
we've been doing the program is going to
be loaded in memory and it's going to be
stored in a special section of memory
called program area and so far we have
been thinking that our program is really
loaded in real memory on our computer
but that's not the case it is an idea of
the memory that the program thinks it
has but it's not the real thing and i am
going to explain but before we explain
let me elaborate on the reason why this
is done if we have many programs and
each program is going to use real memory
on our computer we could quickly run out
of memory because there are many
programs you might even have hundreds or
thousands of programs running on your
computer you may never have enough
memory to run them all if real memory
was used by each program
so the idea was born
to
create what is called virtual memory and
it is a trick that pulls your program
into thinking it is the only program
running on your operating systems and it
owns or the address space or all the
memory on your computer that's what your
program thanks and the view that your
program has of that memory is called a
memory map each program is abstracted
into what we call a process you can
think of rooster.exe
that we have been welding as a process
on the system and each process has
access to the memory range between 0 and
2 to the power of n where n is the
number of bits that your operating
system supports for example i am on a
64-bit operating system so the range for
my memory is going to be between 0 and 2
to the power of 64. and that's a lot of
memory my program is going to think that
it owns all that all and it can never
run out it's going to do whatever it
wants if you are on a 32-bit system
that's going to be between 0 and 2 to
the power of 32 and that's going to be
your virtual memory the amount of memory
that your program fans that it owns and
it happens to be the entirety of your
ram that you have on your system each
program basically thinks that it owns
the entire memory and it can do whatever
it wants okay so we have the rio memory
which is random access memory and we
have virtual memory which is going to be
between 0 and 2 to the power of n okay
so now we're going to update on the idea
of the program execution model because
now we know more we know about virtual
memory here is our c plus program it's
going to go through the compiler and we
are going to generate a binary file
which is going to be a representation of
how things are going to be laid out in
memory in our program
and if we run the program
it is going to go through a section of
the cpu called memory management unit or
mmu for short so that mmu is going to be
basically transforming between the
memory map of each process and the radio
memory layout that we have in ram what
the memory management unit does is
really transform between the
representation we have in the memory map
and the real thing we have in ram the
entire program is not loaded in real
memory by the cpu
only parts of the program that are
really going to be used soon unloaded in
memory and this is going to make
effective use of the memory parts that
are not likely to be used are going to
be discarded from memory and stored on
the hard drive instead and this is
really cool please note that the real
way these things are done is really
complicated but it is buried down into
the logic of the cpu and whatever you
don't really need to worry about this as
a super plus programmer but there are a
few things you need to know as we are
about to see in this lecture so memory
management unit helps out in mapping
between
the memory map you have in your program
basically the idea that your program has
of memory and the real thing
that we have in memory okay here is a
slide that is going to drive this home
we have a few programs with their own
separate memory maps we have program one
through four
if we execute them they are going to go
through the memory management unit and
the memory management unit is going to
assign them sections on the real
ram that we have in our computer and
they are going to be using that section
on the real random access memory that we
have on our computer the thing is your
program is going to really think it owns
the entire thing
but it's not just going to be using a
part of it and the memory management
unit is going to be transforming between
the idea that your program has and the
real memory that we have on our computer
and the memory map is a standard format
that is defined by the operating system
this is why for example you can't take
an executable that was set up on windows
and directly run it on linux this is an
operating system thing the memory map or
the structure of your program is defined
by the operating system that is going to
be running that program so all program
written for an operating system must
conform to the memory map that is
defined by that operating system so all
programs on windows if you had a way to
go in and look at the memory map they
are going to be pretty similar so we
have been talking about the memory map
but
what does it look like
well here is a slide that is going to
try and clear that out so we're going to
have a bunch of memory locations from 0
all the way to 2 to the power of m
and the memory map is really divided
into a lot of parts for example we have
the text section we have the data
section we have the heap stack and
system
and this is one view you can have on
this there are a few different versions
of this slide that you're going to see
on the internet but what is really
important is stack and hip for our
purposes here stack is what is going to
store our local variables thank the a
that we have here in main bc thanks we
had inside functions those things are
stored inside the stack section of our
memory map
besides the stack we also have the hip
which is going to be the location where
we get additional memory we can use to
make things better for our program we
also have the text section which is
going to load the actual binary of our
program so that the cpu can execute it
but we're not going to worry too much
about this section in this course
because it is out of scope for
what we are trying to do here we are
going to focus on stack and hip because
hip is actually going to be very
important from the next lecture when we
start talking about dynamic memory hip
is going to be additional memory that
you can use in your program if you run
out of stack memory and we're going to
see a few other reasons why you might
want to use this as we progress in this
chapter so our memory map is going to
have a lot of parts but the parts that
we really care about in this course are
stack and heap this is really all we set
out to do in this lecture i hope you
have a better idea of the memory map and
how this really works we introduced
another view that you can have on how
your c plus plus program is executed and
i hope you have a better idea of the
memory system and we are going to start
and see how you can work with dynamic
memory allocation which is going to
really use the heap
starting in the next lecture
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to start and
learn about dynamic memory allocation
and this is a technique we can use to
start using hip storage that we have in
the memory map of our c plus plus
program we can use that to get
additional memory we can use and do
stuff if stack memory isn't enough for
our purposes this is how we have been
using pointers so far for example we
have a variable we set up a pointer and
we store the address of the variable n
so we can go ahead and use this pointer
to manipulate the variable or do all
kinds of crazy things if you go down
here we have a pointer p number one
and we have a number one variable and we
can store the address of number one into
this pointer it's really the same thing
like we have on top here but the pointer
is not initialized at declaration here
and you have to make sure you put
invalid data and one thing i haven't
really stressed enough is that it is
really bad
really bad to try and use a pointer that
is not initialized for example here we
have p number two which is a pointer it
is not initialized it contains junk
and we try and write into it okay so try
to think about what we really are doing
here this is a pointer that we have set
up we haven't really initialized that so
it's going to contain whatever address
is possible it can contain an address
that is used by another program it may
contain an address that is being used by
the operating system it's not your
address to mess with and here we are
actually trying to mess with that by
storing in a 55 so this is going to
cause the crash possibly or even
corrupt data that is being used by other
people so don't do this another thing is
to try and use a pointer that is
initialized to know for example here we
have a pointer p number three and it is
braced initialized this is going to
initialize it to null pointer but we are
trying and storing in a value here so
this is also going to be bad it's not
granted what you're going to get
actually c plus doesn't give you any
guarantees this is called undefined
behavior so you're going to get a crash
and don't do it as a good practice the
first thing you should do is initialize
your pointers
before you use them you can initialize
them with no pointer and make sure that
you are
modifying valid addresses into those
pointers if you don't know what is in a
pointer don't use that pointer because
bad things can happen okay rule number
one don't try to use a pointer that you
didn't initialize
rule number two don't try to work with a
pointer that is pointing to no ptr
that's going to give you bad things you
don't want to really deal with okay so
far we have been using memory that lives
on the stack section of our memory map
we were using variables that we have
declared in the main function we were
using the variables that we have
declared inside some functions and
that's all stuff that live on the stack
now we want to see how we can use the
hip okay let's take a closer look at our
memory map we have the stack we have the
heap
and the differences between these two
guys are
laid out here
the stack memory is finite so you don't
have infinite memory but the same is
true for the heap but hip is additional
memory that you can use if you don't
want to run out of stock memory for a
stack memory the developer isn't in full
control of the memory lifetime so if you
declare something on the stack for
example if you say int var1 and you
initialize that to 23 you don't control
when that variable is wiped out of
memory the variable is going to be
killed when the scope in which it was
declared is going to run out
and you developer don't really say when
the variable dies and sometimes you
really want to control
when your variable dies so this is a
limitation we have with the stack memory
okay so for stack memory lifetime is
controlled by the scope mechanism we
just say that for heap the developer is
in full control of when the variable
comes to life and when the variable dies
and this is a benefit you might have
with heap storage and you might want to
use this and we're going to see how we
can use that in the next few lectures
okay so make sure you understand the
difference between stack and hip here if
you look at the example here we have a
variable which is called locoscope var
it is stored within this block delimited
by the curly braces and the variable is
going to come to life when this
statement is executed but it is going to
die
when we hit the closing curly brace here
so the lifetime of this variable is
controlled by the scope mechanism but it
is possible to use dynamic memory or use
memory on the heap and we're going to
see a syntax you can use to do that the
first thing we want to do it to set up
employer that is going to be pointing to
that heap allocated memory the way you
do that you set up a pointer here we
have p number four we initialize it with
no ptr
but what we do to allocate memory is the
second statement here we say p number
four and we say new end
the moment this statement is going to be
executed the operating system is going
to allocate a piece of memory on the
heap the memory is going to be large
enough to accommodate for an integer so
it's going to be four bytes long
and it is your memory now your program
can use it to do whatever it wants and
no other program on the system can use
this piece of memory so it is going to
be yours until you explicitly return
this piece of memory to the system and
we're going to see how you can do that
in a minute once this memory is yours
you can use it you see here we already
referencing the memory and the story
again is 77 and if we're trying to print
this 77 we're going to get it printed
out okay this is how you can use dynamic
memory and when you do this
things are not being stored on the stack
things are being stored on the heap i
really hope you understand this because
it is very important okay so here is our
view of stack and heap so if you use new
to allocate for memory stuff are going
to be stored in this hip section here of
your memory map here is another example
to try and understand the lifetime of
our variables docovar again is limited
to this scope it is going to come into
life when this statement here is
executed and it is going to die when we
run out of this scope here so if you try
executing code out of this scope locovar
is no longer going to be available you
can't use it but that's not the case for
locro ptr var because this is a pointer
it lives on the heap
and if you go out of this scope the
memory is still going to be yours if you
have a way you can access it and use it
you're going to be able to use it and it
is going to be yours until you decide to
return it to the operating system so we
have been talking about returning the
memory to the system
how do we do it well you use the delete
keyword in c plus plus here we have our
memory which is allocated using new and
so the operating system is going to give
us a new piece of memory it is going to
be four bytes because we're going to
store in an integer and we are going to
be pointing to that memory through p
number four here we can use this memory
however we want through the referencing
and do all kinds of crazy things and
when we are done with this memory we are
going to say delete p number four and
this statement is going to return the
memory to the operating system the
memory is no longer going to be hours
after this statement and a good thing to
do after you release your memory is to
reset it to
no ptr so that other people know that
you don't really have any valid data in
that memory because if you try to use a
deleted
memory section bad things are going to
happen that's not going to be your
memory we're going to fall into the same
problem of trying to use an
uninitialized piece of memory don't do
that so whenever you release memory also
reset it to no ptr to play it safe we
can also initialize our pointers with
dynamic memory when we declare them and
this is how you can do it we say p
number five and we initialize that with
new and this is going to give us a new
piece of memory on the heap and it is
going to be pointed to by p number five
we get the same thing here but uh here
we are just pointing in new values and p
number six and p
number seven the memory locations on the
heap are going to be containing 22 and
23 for p number six and p number seven
and here we have a few examples of how
we can print the contents of these
memory locations on htdc out
and after you are done using your hip
memory you're going to release it using
the delete keyword and you are going to
reset that to no ptr to really play it
safe this is how you should use dynamic
memory allocated on the heap another
thing you should know is that it is
really bad to call delete twice on a
pointer so here we have a memory
location that we allocate on the heap we
stored this in a pointer and
we are trying to use it here in sddc
outputting whatever is inside
and if we delete it for the first time
that's going to be cool it is going to
be returned to the system but if you try
to delete it for the second time you're
going to get a crash don't do this this
is really bad okay now that we have a
slightly clearer idea about pointers and
dynamic memory allocation i think it is
time we went to visual studio code and
actually played with a few of these
concepts here we are in our working
directory the current project is dynamic
memory allocation we're going to grab
our template files and we're going to
put them in place dynamic memory
allocation let's do that and we're going
to open this in visual studio code the
first thing we're going to do is review
how we have been using players so far
we have been using them like this we had
a variable stored somewhere on the stack
again this is the stack memory that we
are using here and we
stored addresses of some variables you
know pointers something like this and we
could go through the pointer to
manipulate that memory location for
example
we can print the address of that memory
we can even the reference and print the
value in here
by doing something like we do here and
we are not printing here so let's say
that and say p number we can do
something like this and we have been
doing this quite a lot so far we can
also have a piece of memory that is
uninitialized and we store the address
of some variable in that piece of memory
and we can do the same thing for example
if we print p number one we're going to
get the value 12 printed out here and we
could run this so let's try and do that
we're going to bring up a terminal first
and close this pane so that we have some
breathing room and we are going to build
with gcc like we always do
we're going to build successfully going
to clear and run rooster and we're going
to see that we have these things printed
out here the variable we have in here is
22 so we're going to get that if we
print the variable directly
if we print pointer we're going to get
the address printed out we can also go
through the address of operator to print
the address of this variable here but we
can also print our value through the
referencing our pointer and we can get
access to it here down here we have a
pointer that is not initialized so it
will contain a junk address that you
shouldn't really use but we're not going
to do that because we're going to store
in the address of number one here and we
can manipulate the value here through
the pointer using the the reference
operator here and if we print this p
number one we're going to get 12 printed
out this is pretty cool okay so this is
how we have been using pointers so far
let's comment this out because we're
going to see some other things okay
before we really look at how dynamic
memory works we are going to show you a
few bad things you need to be aware of
so let's put in a piece of code for us
to play with
and here we are saying that writing into
uninitialized memory is really bad so
here we have a pointer it is
uninitialized and we are trying and
directly right into it through the
reference and this is going to be bad
you see that
visual studio code is not complaining it
thinks that we know what we are doing
here and it's not going to warn us but
this pointer could really be pointing
anywhere including operating system
specific memory and here you may be
trying to
modify things that your operating system
is going to need so clearly the
operating system is not going to be
happy about this and the bad things can
happen to this program
so now we have this memory location
we're going to try and write into it and
we're going to see what happens if we
run this program for now let's try and
take this little section here and
comment it out
and we want to see what happens on the
program here the code here that we might
want to run
let's try and build it with gcc we're
going to run the task to do that
the build is going to be good you see
that we don't even get a compiler error
and if we're trying to run rooster you
see that the program is going to try and
run you know the operating system is
going to say this guy doesn't know what
they are doing and i am going to close
them you see that it's not even
running
this statement here let's go on top here
and put in an sddc out statement so that
we can really see
where this program is failing
let's say that stdc out
writing in the 55
okay so this is what we have we have a
few statements other than and we want to
see if we actually get to run these two
things to see
where the program is actually failing
we are going to build it again with gcc
and we are going to clear
and run rooster you see that it's going
to say writing in a 55 but this
statement here is going to fail because
we are trying to ride into memory that
is not ours and the operating system is
going to stop us so our program is
crashing and it is terminating before it
even runs the things that are down here
hopefully you can see how bad this is
you have designed your program to do
things but it is going to stop
without having done any of the other
things that you have designed below so
this is really bad and another bad thing
is that
you might have allocated some dynamic
memory beforehand and your program is
going to end before it even releases
that memory properly and returns that to
the operating system so this is bad you
don't want crashes in your programs and
don't ever try and use and reference
memory that you haven't initialized this
is one bad thing we're going to comment
this out i hope you really know how bad
this is and we're going to go down again
and uncomment what we have done here
and uh it's going to be another bad
thing because we are trying to write
into memory
initialized to null pqr okay here we
have a pointer this is called p number
three and it is initialized with no ptr
you can think of ptr as an address that
says i don't have any valid thing in me
don't use me that's what no ptr is
saying so we have the pointer
initialized to ptr but we are trying to
store something in here and you can
imagine how bad this is this is memory
that isn't really valid the memory
itself is saying i don't contain
anything valid don't try to use me and
if you try to use it bad things are
going to happen so if we try and compile
this program it is going to compile the
compiler is not going to stop us to do
something like this
and these are some things you need to be
aware of in c plus plus but if we try to
run it you're going to see that we are
also going to get a crash again let's
try and put a statement in front of this
failing line and uh below this line i
can say
done writing and i can do
stdndl here
and both of the programs so that we can
see which std statements run and which
dot after our program crashes so we're
going to clear the world is good and run
rooster you're going to see it's going
to say what it's doing it's going to try
and fail and the operating system is
going to kill this program because it is
crazy it is doing what it shouldn't
really be doing so this is something bad
don't do it be aware of this thing okay
we're going to comment this out and
actually look at how we can dynamically
allocate memory from the heap and we're
going to put in a piece of code to play
with that
it's not really complicated we have a
pointer we initialize it with no pointer
to say that this pointer doesn't point
to anywhere valid don't use it and we
are
calling new and when we do this the
operating system is going to give us a
new piece of memory on the heap
this piece of memory is going to have
the size enough to contain it so it's
going to be four bytes in memory and we
are going to be pointing to that piece
of memory using p number four here this
is what we are trying to say here the
moment we do this we own this piece of
memory and nobody else on the operating
system can use it so that's something
you should know once you have it you can
manipulate it through the pointer here
so here we can go through the the
reference operator and store in 77 and
if we print it out we're going to get
that printed out here okay this is
really cool this is the first time we
use hip memory and i am excited about
showing you this thanks we're going to
try and build this program and the build
is going to be good and we are going to
clear this
and if we run rooster we should see a 77
pretty down let's do that
i'm going to get our 77 but this 77 is
stored on the heap now it is not stored
on the stack and this is really
really cool we can control when this
variable comes alive by allocating
memory on the heap and we exactly
control when this variable dies
if we want and we're going to see how we
can kill this variable from memory but
for now just take a moment and
appreciate how good it is to be able to
allocate stuff on the heap it is really
cool now that you have used the memory
it is really time to return it to the
system because we have no more use for
it the way you release memory to the
system is to call the delete keyword
and say the pointer pointing to the
memory that you are trying to release to
the system so we're going to say p
number four here let's bring this down a
little bit so that you can see the
entire story so we have a pointer here
and it is pointing to dynamically
allocated memory from the heap this
memory is four bytes
large because it stores an integer
we have it dynamically allocated we use
it here and it is time to return it to
the operating system okay i hope this is
clear the moment you call the delete
keyword
now the memory is going to be containing
some junk and you don't want to really
use that anymore if you try to use it
it's not your memory you're going to run
into trouble so for example after we
delete this memory if we try to use it
i'm going to show you here i think i can
let's say p number four and um storing
something notice that we are using the
the reference operator and let's try and
put in a 45 why not
so let's build this with gcc as we
always do it is going to world compiler
is not going to stop you from doing
something like this
writing into memory that you have
already
released to the system but we're going
to see what happens so run rooster and
it is going to say done writing but you
see that the program has really crashed
because here we are trying to write into
memory that we don't really own and this
is bad don't do this so the moment you
delete the memory or the moment you
return the memory to the operating
system it is good practice to reset that
memory to no ptr so we're going to say p
number four and
make sure it contains no ptor
at least when we do this other people
have a chance to check and see that
that's valid memory before they use it
that's the use of resetting your memory
here so this is something you should do
again the flow to use dynamic memory is
really simple you set up a pointer that
is going to point to your memory
you're going to
allocate the memory from the heap using
the new operator you're going to specify
the type you want to allocate memory for
the operating system is going to give
you that memory and you're going to be
pointing to that memory with your
pointer you are going to manipulate that
memory using your pointer and doing all
kinds of crazy things and after you are
done with that memory you're going to
release it to the operating system and
please
please remember to reset your pointers
after you have deleted them like this
that's going to make your life a whole
lot easier and other developers are
going to thank you for doing this
when they get to use your code because
your code is going to be much safer to
work with okay let's comment this out
and show you another example of what
cool things you can do with dynamic heap
memory we're going to go down and put in
a piece of code and show you that you
can actually
dynamically initialize your pointers at
declaration this is something you can do
the first one is not initialized so it's
going to contain junk volume p number
five if we try to print it we're going
to get some junk address print it out p
number six we're going to dereference it
and print the value inside so we're
going to see that and we can do the same
thing for p number six and p number
seven after we are done using the
pointers we are going to release the
memory here and notice that we are
resetting the pointers to no pointer to
say that they don't really contain
anything useful don't use them make sure
you have something valid and before you
use them this is the meaning here if
you're trying to run the program you can
guess what we're going to see so try and
guess and we're going to build we're
going to weld successfully going to
clear
clear not clear and we're going to run
rooster and we're going to see that p
number five contains some junk address
okay and if we try to dereference that
we're going to get a junk value this is
really not useful don't use this value
because you didn't put this value in in
the first place you're going to see that
p number 6 is going to point to some
other address but we're going to have a
valid value inside because we have put
that n at initialization here the same
is true for p number seven it's going to
point to some address and we're going to
have 23 and because we put in our 23.
this is how you really use these
pointers another thing i want you to
know is that even if we have called
delete and reset these pointers they are
still available for use in our program
so if we want we can reuse these
pointers so for example p number five we
can take it
and use it to allocate new memory so we
can say new and
and uh store an 81 why not
okay so we can go down here and use that
this is going to be valid c plus plus
code
okay take a moment and look at it it is
p number five not p number
and the visual studio code is going to
take this because it is valid c plus
plus code the memory has been returned
to the operating system and the pointer
has been reset to no ptr but we can
reuse this end pointer to allocate new
memory so we are allocating new memory
on the heap the memory is going to be
four bytes because it is
going to contain an integer and we are
using this pointer
to point to that new memory so this
pointer is being reused it was pointing
to
the memory that we allocated here which
was uninitialized and we are using that
to point to new
memory location on the hip i really want
you to understand these things because
many beginners get them wrong and it is
hard to correct these things in your
mind once you have a wrong idea about
them in the first place so make sure you
understand this so if we print this
we're going to get the 81 printed out
but
we have allocated new memory we have to
remember to release it again so we have
to come and say delete
p number five and we need to reset it to
no pointer
and we're going to do that
right here
once we do this we're going to be
playing it safe let's try and run and
see that we see the at1 printed out
we're going to build with gcc the world
is going to go through
and we are going to clear and run
rooster and you see that we see our 81
and we don't have any crazy crash for
example to prove that we don't have a
crash we can say that our program is
ending well
is ending well
and uh
we're going to know
if the program has actually reached the
end before it dies we're going to build
again
with gcc
and we're going to clear
and run rooster and you're going to see
that the program is ending well
the other thing i want you to see is
that it is really bad to call delete
twice on a pointer again it is really
bad to call delete twice on a pointer
don't do that okay we're going to see an
example of that here
so we're going to allocate new memory
using p number five why not so we're
going to say p number five and we're
going to say new and going to allocate
new memory on the heap and we're going
to store in a 99 in that memory we can
print out the 99 so we're going to say
and after we are done using this memory
we are a good c plus plus citizen so
we're going to call delete
and say p number five
okay this is good it is going to work if
we will then run we're going to get what
we expect we should get a 99 printed out
last in our program before it ends and
we see that printed out here program
ending well this is really cool
but if we try to call delete twice
and say p number five again
and try to boil you see that the
compiler is not going to stop us because
it thanks
we know what we are doing
so this is something you need to be
aware of in c plus plus if we run this
program
you're going to see ah the program is
not going to end well the c plus plus
runtime or the operating system is going
to get here and see uh this guy is
trying to release memory twice and i
don't do that this is a bad program i am
going to kill it and it is going to be
killed the bad thing again is that
anything you have in your program after
these lines is not going to run because
the operating system is going to kill
your program at this line here so if you
had memory allocated that you planned to
release later on in your program your
memory is not going to be released
because those statements to release the
memory will never be run this is where
the program is going to be killed the
operating system is going to see that
you are a rug program and it is going to
kill the program so don't delete your
memory twice this is something you
should really watch out for and you
might think uh-huh i know this why would
i call delete twice in a single line
here well you may not do it like this
but your program might have multiple
files
where you have pointers pointing to the
same memory and if you try to delete
that memory twice you're going to get
this error and this is really good so
watch out for these kinds of things and
we're going to see different ways you
can
use to really make sure you are doing
things right in c plus plus this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture giving you first-hand practice
on how to do dynamic memory allocation i
hope you found this useful we are going
to stop here in this lecture and the
next one we're going to learn about
dangling pointers
go ahead and finish up here and we'd be
there in this lecture we're going to
focus on dangling pointers and show you
how they can be bad a dangling pointer
is a pointer that is pointing to a valid
address and we have seen a few examples
of this already but in this lecture
we're going to focus on that and show
you common solutions we can apply to
these problems here and download
pointers are really bad they are going
to lead you programs to undefined
behavior and we have seen that that can
crush your program
many times there are three kinds of
dangling pointers we're going to look at
in this lecture the first one is a
pointer that is not initialized the
second one is a deleted pointer and the
third case may come if you have multiple
pointers pointing to the same memory
location and let's look at these cases
one by one here we have an example of a
pointer that is not properly initialized
this is p number five it is a pointer to
end
and it is not initialized it doesn't
really point anywhere and it is going to
contain junk address if we try to
dereference it we're going to get bad
things to happen because we don't really
know which address is stored in there
and putting something in there might
lead to a crash so this is something you
need to watch out for the second kind of
dangling pointer that can really lead
you to bad places is a deleted pointer
here is a pointer p number one it is
initialized with dynamic memory and we
can use it for example here we are
dereferencing the pointer and printing
the value inside and deleting the
pointer after we delete the pointer
don't really use it before you properly
initialize it with some kind of memory
if we try to do that this is going to be
undefined behavior and your program
might crash so make sure you don't do
something like this another case is if
you have multiple pointers pointing to
the same address and here is a simple
example to drive the point home we have
pointer three which is pointing to
dynamic memory here we are using new ant
in our braced initializer and we are
putting value 83 in that pointer
location
and here we set up another pointer p
number four and we initialize that with
another pointer and if we print these
things out we're going to get that they
contain the same address and they
contain the same value we're going to
see that
if we delete p number three
and try to use p number four later we're
going to get problems because this
memory has been deleted by p number
three
but p number four is still pointing to
that and if it tries to use that it's
going to be deleted memory basically and
we're going to get undefined behavior so
be sure you know these problems and try
to avoid them in your programs okay
these are problems but how do we solve
them well there are a few solutions one
is to always initialize your pointers
the moment you declare a pointer make
sure it is initialized if you don't know
what you can initialize that pointer
with put in null pointer first and then
you're going to put in an address later
when you have a clear idea of which
address you can store in the second
solution is to reset your pointers to
now ptr after you delete the memory
that's the second thing you should do
every time you call delete that's going
to give other developers or even
yourself a chance to check and see if
that memory location
contains a valid address before you do
that and for multiple pointers pointing
to the same address you have to choose
and make one pointer the master of the
controller of the memory
and all pointers are basically going to
be slaves which can't release the memory
but they can read and do something with
that memory that they don't have the
task of releasing that memory and here
is how you can apply solution one for
example we have pointer number five and
we're going to brace initialize it this
is going to initialize it to
null pointer the other thing you can do
is initialize the pointer with dynamic
memory like we are doing here with p
number six and this is going to put in
the value and we are going to be playing
on the safe side
now if your pointers are initialized
developers have a chance to check your
pointers against no ptr to see that they
contain something valid before they use
it and if they see that it contains no
ptr they are not going to try and use it
and this is going to be very safe for
the second problem with deleted pointers
we are going to reset our pointers after
we call delete for example here we have
pin number seven initialized with
dynamic memory and 82 is stored in we
can print it out all do things with it
when we delete the memory we're going to
reset it to null p2r so that other
developers or even ourselves can check
this memory against no ptr and if it's
different from no ptr we can use it if
it's equal to no ptr we're going to
leave it alone and do something else
this is going to be very safe if you
have multiple pointers pointing to the
same address like we have here then
you're going to have to decide which
pointer is the master pointer and other
pointers are going to be
slave pointers and before use
all the other pointers are going to
check against the master pointer and see
that it contains valid memory because
the master pointer has the task of
deleting this memory let's go through
this and see how this could work in
practice
so p number five is our master pointer
we are setting p number five and
initializing it with p number eight we
are creating things using p number eight
we can either use p number eight or pin
urban eye this is going to work but
before we use the memory location we're
going to check against the master
pointer if the master pointer contains
no ptr we're not going to use this
memory if the master pointer doesn't
contain now ptr we're going to use this
memory here okay if you go down you see
that the master pointer is going to be
releasing the memory and if we try to
use that memory after it was deleted
we're going to see that it contains now
ptr and we're not going to be using it
this is something cool and it is really
easy to implement this safety guidelines
in your programs now that you know about
this we're going to go to visual studio
code and show you this in action okay
here we are in our working directory the
current project is dangling pointers so
we're going to grab our template files
pretty quick and put that in our project
and we're going to open this in visual
studio code we are going to look at the
first case of a dangling pointer and
this is a pointer that is not
initialized properly like p number here
if we try to reference it we're going to
get something bad to happen
so let's see that and let's go down and
say that program is ending well just to
know that we didn't get a crash because
a crash is basically going to terminate
your program on the offending line
that's what it's going to do so if the
program
works well and ends well we're going to
print this line here
let's bring in
gcc to build this program and let's open
a terminal so that we can
run it we're going to clear the world
was good
and we're going to run rooster
you see that the program didn't end well
it crashed and it crashed because we are
trying to use
uninitialized memory when the operating
system is going to try and run this
thing it's going to see ah this guy is
trying to modify memory that doesn't
really belong to him it is a road
program i am going to kill it and it is
going to be terminated on this line here
this is really bad
you should avoid these kinds of
situations so don't do this we are going
to comment this out and show you another
offending event we can do in our program
and that is using a deleted pointer if
you do that you're going to get
something bad in your programs
so here we have a small example we have
a pointer to end we initialize this with
a dynamic piece of memory and we're
going to store in a 67
and we can print this out this is going
to work pretty well
but
we delete the memory down here and we
try to use it after we have deleted the
memory so the operating system is not
going to be happy about this because
once the memory is deleted it is no
longer our memory so we have no business
the referencing pointer one and trying
to use that here and we're going to get
a crush
and this is something you should avoid
so let's try and build this and show you
this in action we are going to clear
and run rooster
and you're going to see that program is
ending well but in some cases it might
crash and hopefully this shows you the
danger
that these things might put you into
sometimes your program is going to seem
working fine but sometimes when this
memory that we are pointing to in p
number one here is being used to do
something really important by the
operating system you are going to get a
crash so you're not guaranteed to get
the same behavior every time you run
your program some of you might be saying
aha the program is working here daniel
why are you making this such a big deal
well it is a big deal because you are
not guaranteed to get the same results
every time you run this program so be
sure you really avoid these kinds of
situations let's try and clear and run
the program again hopefully we're going
to see it crash but we're not okay so
let's clear and rebuild again
and see that we have a better luck that
time
that's clear
and run rooster it is going to end well
but you notice that we are trying to use
a piece of memory that has already been
deleted and this is bad don't do this
make sure you don't do something like
this we're going to comment this out
again and show you another offending
thing we can do with our programs and
bad things might happen if you try to
have multiple pointers played into the
same address and that's what we have
here we have p number three and p number
four here p number three is allocating
new space and it is pointing to it we
have an 83 inside and a p number four is
initialized with p number three we can
do that so these two pointers are
basically pointing to the same memory
location
let's run this and show you that
we're going to comment out this delete
statement here and run the program first
to really prove that they are pointing
to the same addresses and they contain
the same values let's build and run
we're going to use gcc for that
and we're going to clear and run rooster
and you see that
p number three the address is this and
it contains an 83 p number four contains
the same thanks
so let's see what happens if we try to
delete using p number three
and using p number four later to try and
read stuff this is what we are doing
here
and we're going to see if the program
actually gets to end well
we're going to build again the world is
going to be good let's bring this up and
clear and run rooster
and you're going to see that the program
is also going to end well
but we are using a deleted piece of
memory here and anything can really
happen okay so you might get garbage you
might have really any piece of junk
inside or you might get a crush in some
extreme cases so this is really bad
don't do it don't try to use a piece of
memory that you have already deleted
through a pointer and these are problems
you might run into in your programs if
you try to use dynamic memory allocation
let's look at how we can solve them
and the
ultimate advice
is to
make sure you put a little ptr in a
pointer if you don't know what that
pointer is actually stored at okay let's
go down and look at solution one
solution one is to initialize your
pointer to no pointer every time if you
don't have a value you can put in use
null ptr that's what we are using here
implicitly but we can explicitly put
that end because it is good and before
you use a pointer you have to check and
see if it doesn't contain null pointer
this is how we do it if pointer six is
different from null pointer we're going
to use it if it is equal to no pointer
we're not going to use it and we're
going to be playing on the safe side and
you're going to see that the program is
going to end well here if we have a null
ptr inside we can say
else here
and say
invalid address okay and that the user
is going to know that they are trying to
do something really bad so let's try and
check against p number five
so let's go and store a null pointer in
p number six to really try this out and
show you that we're going to get this
warning if we're trying to use it
and we're going to build with gcc and
we're going to clear and run rooster
you're going to see that invalid address
and the program is going to end well
and if we try to put this statement
somewhere where we're not shaking
against
no pointer we are going to get a crash
so let's comment this out so that it's
clear what it is we are running here
so if we run this we're going to get a
crash we have seen that but let's show
this again
and really highlight that we are solving
the problem here if we run rooster the
program is going to crash because we are
trying to use
uninitialized
memory but if we try and check against
no ptr like we are doing here let's do
that we're going to be playing on the
safe side because it's going to tell us
invalid address and we're not going to
get a crush and the program is going to
end well this is really cool so let's
try and do that again we're going to
world
the world is going to be good we can
clear and run rooster and the program is
going to end well okay so if we have a
value inside we're going to get that so
let's put that n and say new ant and put
in an 87 for example it doesn't really
matter what we put in
so we're going to build again the work
is going to be good and we can run
rooster and you see that we are getting
a value here if we are not storing no
ptlr in p number six and you can do the
same checks against p number five but i
think this is really enough so this is
one way you can avoid dangling pointers
the next thing we're going to look at is
if we are using a deleted pointer and
again the solution is to set a pointer
to no ptr
after we delete it here we have p number
seven it has 82 inside we are using it
here and printing stuff out we're going
to delete it after we are done using it
and after that
the first thing we do is to reset it to
no ptr when we do that other people or
even ourselves have a chance to check it
against no ptr and we're going to know
that it doesn't contain anything
useful
for our program and if we do something
like this
we're not going to run into all these
weird problems
and our program is going to have
consistent behavior
across different runs and this is really
cool so we're going to run this we're
going to get things printed out and the
program is going to end well because
right now we are checking against no ptr
we can even be explicit in showing the
warning here we can say invalid memory
access and if you run this program
you're going to really know this so
let's finish this up and we're going to
bolt and the bulk is going to be good if
we run this and run rooster we're going
to know that we are doing any valid
memory access after we have deleted the
pointer and this is going to save you
from possible crashes that you might
experience if you don't do this so this
is a second solution you might want to
implement in your programs
and i'm going to comment it out and show
you how you can get away from the
problem of when you have
multiple pointers pointing to the same
address we are going to go down and put
in the code it is what you have seen in
the slides and it is really nothing new
so we have pointer eight and pointer
nine here and p number eight here is
pointing to
dynamic memory
and the value inside is 382
p number nine is initialized with
whatever we have in p number eight so
they are going to be pointing to the
same addresses here but we have made p
number eight the master pointer so it is
the only pointer that is going to be
able to delete this memory location even
if we have multiple pointers pointing to
that
okay so every time we want to use this
memory we have the option to check
against the master pointer and see that
we have some valid data inside if it is
no pointer we're not going to use that
and we're going to be playing on the
safe side this is really what we are
doing here if we run this we're going to
see that the program is going to end
well
the world is going to be good and if we
run rooster we're going to see that we
get things printed out we're going to go
through p number eight we're going to
print stuff we're going to go through p
number nine we're going to print stuff
and if we try to use the pointer
after the
memory has been deleted we're going to
get a clear warning that we are trying
to do something really bad and this is
really what you should aim for in your c
plus plus programs that use dynamic
memory allocation and pointers
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you know how you can
avoid these problems with dangling
pointers we are going to stop here in
this lecture the next lecture we're
going to see what can happen
if this new operator
fails to give you the memory that you
want to allocate on the heap and that's
possible go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to explore what happens when new
fails in the last lecture we saw that we
could use the new operator to allocate
for new memory on the heap and use that
to do stuff and in most cases the new
operator is going to succeed but in some
rare cases it is going to fail and when
you don't do anything about that failure
your program is just going to crash and
you might want to do something about
that i have to say that it is very rare
for new to fail in practice so you're
going to see a lot of code out there
that just uses the new operator it
doesn't really care about
checking if the operation actually
failed or succeeded so this is a very
rare case but if you need to handle it
we're going to see how you can do that
in this lecture here is a simple example
that is going to try and force the new
operator to fail
in the first segment here we are using
the new operator but we are using a
syntax that is going to try and allocate
a lot of integers in one go you see that
it is an array but we haven't really
seen how we can use an array like this
so just think of this code as a piece of
code that is going to allocate a lot of
integers in one go and we're going to
try and make this fail
i have to say that this may give you an
error on some compilers saying that you
are exceeding the array size if that's
the case no problem we're going to find
another way to get this new operator to
fail we are going to put a thing like
this in a loop and we're going to loop a
lot of times enough to exhaust the heap
that is allocated to our program here
and when that happens you're going to
see that the program is going to crash
and it is bad so new can fail and if you
need to play on the server side you're
going to
handle that problem and we have two ways
we can handle this problem we can go
through the exception mechanism this is
a built-in way we have in c plus plus to
check for arrows and handle them we can
also use the std no throw setting
in our new operator and force it not to
throw an exception and it's going to
give us no pointer if the allocation
fails i know this might sound cryptic
right now but we're going to see an
example shortly and you're going to
understand this let's look at how we can
use the exception mechanism the
exception mechanism is there in c plus
plus to let you handle problems when
they arise and the way you use that you
wrap code that is potentially going to
give you problems
and try and catch blocks you see here
inside the loop we are saying try
and inside the tri blocks we have the
code that could fail we have our new
operator
and in the catch block you see we have a
catch block here we're going to
say that we have a problem
and we have a way of catching the
problem and if you look at this thing we
have in this parenthesis after catch we
have an ex variable and we can ask it
what kind of problem happened
leading to this exception happening in
our code you can think of this like this
i realize we haven't really talked about
exceptions we are going to talk about
them later in the course when we have
enough tools to really understand what
is happening but now
think of them as a tool to handle
when the new operator fails and you're
not going to crash your program your
program will keep running it will go
through the end but the new operation
that you wanted to do here will fail and
you will be able to catch that and this
is a good thing if you don't want to use
exceptions you can use the std no throw
option
and this is a new version of the new
operator you can use to tell the c plus
plus system to not throw an exception
when the operation fails it is just
going to return no pointer and you can
check for that and know that memory
allocation actually failed this is what
we're going to talk about in this
lecture i hope you have an idea about
this we're going to head over to visual
studio code and actually try this in
action okay here we are in our working
directory the current project is when
new fails
we are going to grab our template files
like we always do and we're going to put
them in place so when new fails that's
the lecture so we're going to do that
and open this in visual studio code
pretty quick and we are going to try and
allocate a large piece of memory in one
go so the way you do that we can do say
end pointer
let's call this data it really doesn't
matter and we're going to say new and
and we're going to say that we want a
huge amount of events
let's try and do that and we're going to
go down and say program
ending well to make sure
we know when we are ending this program
properly so let's try and compile this
we're going to bring up the terminal and
we are going to weld with gcc as we
always do and the build is going to be
good let's try and increase this number
and push it to a really big number and
you see that we
have made visual studio code mad here
array is too large so they can't really
allow us
to do
a really large array in here okay so
let's bring this down a little bit
and if we're trying to compile the
bullet is going to be good and if we run
rooster you see that the program
is going to not end well okay so this is
really a case where new fails we can't
really allocate this much
on the heap storage that is allocated to
this program here remember when we
revisited the memory map idea we saw
that each program is going to have its
own memory map the memory map is going
to have a lot of sections inside we have
the stack we have the heap our hip is
not infinite so we can run out and we
just ran out with this allocation that
we did here and our program is going to
terminate immediately you see that it is
not ending well
if this is not working for whatever
compiler you are using we can go and do
this through a loop so what we can do we
can
comment this out and we can really loop
many many times enough to exhaust the
memory that is allocated for this
process here rooster.exe
in the memory map in the hip section
that's what i mean and if we do this at
some point the program is going to fail
and we're going to get the same problem
here so let's build again
we're going to build with gcc
and we are going to clear and run
rooster and we're going to see it's
going to loop loop loop and it's going
to fail we're going to see
the failure in a minute and we need to
find a way to solve this problem we have
seen that we have two options let's
comment this out
and uh look at those solutions here the
first option is to go through the
exception mechanism we can also use the
std no throw option we're going to try
the exception mechanism first and uh
what we do
is wrap possibly offending code in try
and catch blocks and we're going to say
try here and put a block and we're going
to say
catch and we're going to say std
exception and we're going to put an
ampersand symbol here just use this like
this and we're going to get a chance to
really explain these things when we have
enough tools to understand this for now
think of this as if i have code that is
potentially going to fail
like the new operator here i am going to
put that in the try block
and if something goes wrong we're going
to get the error in the catch block this
is the way we do these things here so
for example i can take my loop here
and copy it
and put that down below here
okay
and i know that this line of code could
fail okay
so i am going to wrap that inside try
and catch blocks so i am going to grab
that
and put that in my loop
let's do that and align this a little
bit
and we are going to take the potentially
offensive code
and put that
in the try block and when the operator
here fails
something goes wrong and we're going to
catch the problem in the catch block
this is what we mean here again we don't
have enough tools to understand why we
are doing this thing here what is the
meaning of this ampersand symbol we're
going to learn about that later in the
course but for now we want to put
together something good enough for this
program not to crash like it was doing
right here okay we're going to catch the
arrow and say something went wrong
and we're going to print out what
actually went wrong we're going to say
ex and we can call
a function called what on this
and we can say sdd
endl
let's hide this pen here because we want
to see clearly what is happening here
this is how you can prevent your program
from crashing and it is going to end
well because now we have handled the
problem and that we haven't caused a
crash
like we were doing down here now we're
going to try and build this code let's
bring it up a little bit so that it is
not messy here
and we're going to weld with gcc the
bolt is going to be good and we're going
to clear and run rooster and it is going
to do its thing it's going to keep
looping around
and it's going to say something went bad
it's going to hit a point where all
these allocations are going to fail and
if we really wait for it it is going to
end and we're going to see that it's
going to end well
let's try and hit ctrl c and terminate
it because we don't want to wait for
this amount of time
and let's bring that
down to 100 and increase this number
here
let's see if that actually works so
we're going to boil for now we just want
to see that the program is not really
crushing
so we're going to run rooster and you
see that
it's going to keep running and at some
point
it's going to fail to allocate memory
and it's going to say something went
wrong but if you keep going down you're
going to see that the program is ending
well
so what is happening here is that
the new operator actually failed
but we code the problem and could handle
it in here so what is called handling
the problem
you're going to handle it in whatever
makes sense in your program if we were
for example trying to set up a color in
some
widgets in your application and the
color fails and you fail to set up the
color you may show your user interface
in black and white and keep running your
program instead of getting it crashed
this is just a way to show you
that you can handle stuff
when new fails this is one way we can
solve the problem so we're going to look
at the second way
the exception mechanism is the first
so we're going to comment this out
because we're going to see another way
and let's do that we can also use the
std no throw setting on our new operator
when we are
allocating for new memory so we're going
to do that and we're going to bring up
our loop here
we're going to reuse that for this here
we're not going to be using the
exception mechanism so we're going to do
something like this get rid of the try
and catch block but we're going to still
be in a loop here
so what we can do is pass the new
operator a parameter and say std no
throw and when we do this if new fails
we are going to get no pointer stored in
data here so we can check this against
the null pointer we can say
f
data is different from null pointer
and we can do whatever we want to do we
can do that and say
sddc out
get it allocated and we can try and
compile this program
so what we're going to do is run this
through our compiler through gcc
and you're going to see that the world
is going to be good and you see that
visual studio code was giving us a
squiggly line because it can't really
understand this but this is going to go
through the compiler and it is going to
work exactly how we expect
so let's try and run this program
we're going to ignore visual studio code
for now because the world was good we
could build with gcc and we saw that
this was welding successfully so we can
clear
let's clear properly and run rooster and
it's going to say data allocated a few
other times and the program is going to
end you see that the program is not
crashing because we are also handling
the problem but we are going through a
new mechanism to do that and that's
using the std no throw option with our
new operator here this is really all we
set out to do in this lecture i hope it
is very clear that the new operator can
fail and you have a couple of options at
your hands to handle things when new
fails you can either go through the
exception mechanism by using try and
catch blocks like we did here or you can
use the std no throw option we are going
to stop here in this lecture and the
next one we are going to learn about no
pointer safety
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
explore the concept called null pointer
safety and this is a series of measures
you take to make sure that when you are
using a pointer it contains a valid
address if you don't have a valid
address inside you don't use that
pointer and we do that through a series
of checks we can do against the null
pointer for example here we have a
pointer that is initialized to null
pointer
implicitly through braced initializers
and what we can do is check if p number
doesn't contain
null pointer and this is how we say it
in c plus and if it contains no pointer
we're not going to use it we're going to
say it points to an invalid address this
is something you can do it is simple in
nature but it is going to save you lots
of trouble this is one version we can do
this on but we can also directly plug in
p number and use it like this if it
contains no pointer we're going to get
the message printed out that we have an
invalid address if we have something
other than no pointer we're going to
have a valid address and we can do
something with that this is going to
work because a pointer can also be
implicitly converted into a boolean
expression that our if statement expects
here and it is going to work exactly how
we want here so we're going to see this
in a minute when we hit visual studio
code before we do that though i want you
to be aware that you can call
delete on a pointer containing no
pointer without doing the check here it
is going to be okay we have seen many
rules about pointers and many students
will develop an intuition that you have
to check for no pointer before you do
anything on your pointer and they even
do that before they call delete i have
to break it to you that it is safe to
call delete on a pointer that contains
null pointer so you don't need to do
something like we have here say and
check if p number one and then delete p
number one and reset that to low pointer
this is really overkill you can call
delete on the pointer and it is going to
be fine even if it contains no pointer
now we're going to go to visual studio
code and see these things in action here
we are in our working directory the
current project is no pointer safety
we're going to grab our template project
and we're going to put that in the
current project that we are interested
in
and we are going to open this in visual
studio code open folder and we are going
to put in a verbose no pointer check
what we are doing here is nothing new we
have a pointer called p number it is a
pointer to ant and it is initialized to
null pointer through implicit
initialization here using braced
initialization and we are checking to
see if it contains null pointer if it
does
we're going to say it contains an
invalid address if it doesn't we're
going to say that it has a valid address
and you see that we are using a negation
here you can do this however you want if
we try to build this
with gcc let's see what we get
the vote is going to go through
and if we run rooster we're going to see
that p number points to an invalid
address because it contains
null pointer but if we try and set up a
new variable for example and say p
number
and let's use dynamic memory we have
learnt about that and initialize that
with a 7 for example and when it points
to a valid address we're going to print
whatever is in there we know how to do
that so we can say p number and we're
going to print whatever is inside and
say p number through the reference end
and we're going to say stdndl now the
pointer is not going to contain
no pointer because it contains the
address
of the memory that was allocated on the
hip here
but once we do that we have to remember
to release this memory so please
remember to release your memory after
you are done using it so we're going to
say delete p number after that and we
need to reset it to no pointer in this
case it really is useless because nobody
is going to be using this pointer
anymore the program is about to end but
it is a good practice to do this even in
this case because once this way of doing
events is burnt into your memory it has
become your habit you're going to be
writing cipher c plus plus code now
we're going to try and run this so we're
going to build again the bold is going
to go through and it is going to say
that
we have a valid address in memory which
is this guy and what is inside is a
seven and now we are writing cipher c
plus plus code through null pointer
safety here we can also do a direct
check using p number without checking if
it is equal to null pointer because this
is verbose but it is something you will
see in practice you can also do
something like this and say if p number
and you're going to get exactly the same
thing so if we have some valid
address inside we're going to print
that let's print the same thing as
in the
previous code here
and if we build and run we're going to
get exactly the same thing
okay so that's
clear because the world is good let's
clear and run rooster you see that we
get exactly the same thing and if we
didn't initialize this guy with the new
dynamic piece of memory we're going to
get that the memory is invalid the
address we have in the pointer is going
to be invalid and we're going to print
that out through our code here
run rooster invalid address
okay the last thing i want you to see is
that it is okay to call delete
on a null pointer and we're going to say
that here so we're going to go down here
and put in a piece of code we are
setting up a new pointer p number one
initialized with no pointer if we call
delete on it this is going to work
really well and you're not going to get
a crush or anything this is valid c plus
plus code so if we're trying to compile
this it is going to work fine and you
don't really have to
do a no pointer check before you delete
like this because that's overkill you
see that the program both successfully
and we can clear and run it and we're
going to get exactly the same things we
had before so some people are going to
do something like
they're going to check for no pointer
and they're going to say if p number one
for example is not equal to no pointer
and they're going to say something like
delete here and they're going to do
something like this
and this is going to work but it is
really overkill you don't need to do
this test because it is safe to call
delete on a pointer even if it contains
no pointer in the first place so you
don't need to do things like this this
is going to work just fine don't be
afraid to call delete on a pointer
because it might contain null pointer
this is really all we mean by null
pointer safety and i hope i gave you a
few examples to make this pretty clear
we are going to stop here in this
lecture the next one we're going to
learn about memory licks
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about memory leaks
and a memory leak is when you have lost
access to a piece of memory that was
dynamically allocated to your program
you basically lose the pointer that was
pointing to that dynamically allocated
piece of memory here we have a few
examples of that for example here we
have p number which contains a
dynamically allocated piece of memory
which is going to contain an integer
it's going to be 4 byte the value inside
is going to be a 67. this p number is
our only key to manipulate that memory
and it is the key through which we even
go to release that memory and return
that to the operating system but notice
what we do down here
we are setting up a new number variable
it is an integer and it is allocated on
the stack because this is a local
variable it's not a pointer it's not
dynamically allocated and we take the
address of number and assign that to our
pointer the moment we do that
we have no way to release the memory
that was allocated to p number in the
first place
and if we do that the operating system
is going to think that this memory is
ours but we don't have a way to release
this memory anymore because the pointer
that was
helping us access this memory has been
repurposed to point to this number
variable here i hope you see that
and the memory leak is something like
this when you lose the pointer that
would otherwise be used to release the
memory and your program is basically
going to keep using this memory and the
operating system is not going to have a
way to reclaim this memory so it is
useless so you are no longer using this
memory because you can't access it and
do things with it and the operating
system can't use it either because it
fences your memory hopefully you can see
that this is a really bad situation and
you should avoid these things in your
application so do avoid memory leaks
like a plague
this is one situation in which we can
have a memory leak here is another
example where we have double allocation
we have a pointer p number one it is
pointing to dynamically allocated memory
again and the value inside is a 55.
if we use this pointer to allocate new
memory the first memory that we were
pointing to is going to be leaked
again it is the same thing we have lost
access to the first memory now we are
pointing to the second dynamic
memory that was allocated to contain the
44 here and again this is a memory leak
your program has lost access to the
memory containing 55 here and the
operating system also thinks that you
are using this memory because you didn't
explicitly return it to the operating
system through the delete operator again
memory leaks are bad do avoid them in
your programs here is another simple
example of a case where you might have a
memory leak you go in a nested scope
like this and allocate a new piece of
memory dynamically of course and point
to that through p number two here but p
number two
itself is a pointer and it is a local
variable nested in this scope
when this scope ends p number two is
going to die but the dynamic memory
itself is not going to die you just lost
access to it and you can't access it
again this is a memory leak and you
should avoid this in your programs
memory leaks are really bad and in
extreme cases they might even lead to
your program crashing if your program
keeps running for an extended period of
time think of programs like those
running in servers for example they can
even run for three months without
stopping and if your program is
increasingly leaking memory the
operating system is going to think that
you are taking too much hip memory it's
going to terminate your program like we
saw
in the lecture where we learned on
conditions where the new operator failed
so if you allocate too much memory then
your program can really take the next
operations you're going to do with new
are going to fail and your program is
going to terminate the message here is
memory leaks are bad you should avoid
them in your programs and whenever you
think that you're no longer using a
piece of memory make sure you delete it
and return it to the operating system
you're going to be writing much safer c
plus plus code we're going to head over
to visual studio code and actually try
this here we are in our working
directory the current project is memory
leaks we're going to bring in our
template files
and we're going to put them in place in
the lecture on memory leaks and we are
going to open this in visual studio code
we are going to clean this up a little
bit bring this up here we have a
variable called p number it is a pointer
to end and we initialize that with the
address of a piece of memory that is
allocated dynamically on the heap we
store a 67 inside and here down you see
we set up another variable on the stack
again this says a stack variable
it lives on the stack it's not on the
heap and we text the address of this
thing and assign that to our pointer
here the moment we do that we have no
more way we can access this dynamic
memory and we have leaked it and this is
really bad the thing is this program is
going to compile
i don't think compilers have a way to
stop you from making mistakes like this
so you really have to be careful and
make sure that you are not leaking
memory in your program so if we run this
program it's going to run it's going to
run and finish let's say that it is
ending well okay so we're going to build
and see this run the build is good so we
can clear and run rooster and we're
going to see that the program is ending
well but we are
leaking memory here because the
dynamically piece of memory that we
allocated here
wasn't released to the system and when
we did this assignment here we just lost
access to it so the operating system is
going to thank this memory belongs to
this program that is ours here but your
program is either not going to be using
this piece of memory because we have
just lost the key
that would allow us to go and do
something useful with this memory here
so this is something bad and you should
avoid it the second example of memory
leaks is when you do double allocation
on a pointer for example here we have
pin number one again and we are going to
make this point to
an address
of a piece of memory that was allocated
dynamically on the heap the value inside
is going to be 55 but we are using this
pointer again to make it point to a new
piece of memory containing the address
of the newly allocated piece of memory
on the stack on the heap i mean and this
is really bad because again once we do
this we lose access to this memory here
and it is linked
the program here is not going to have
access to it and the operating system is
going to thank we own this memory and it
is going to be bad and uh down here
maybe you can go and say delete number
one p number one but this is not going
to release the memory here it is going
to release the memory here with the 44
and the memory containing 55 here is
going to be leaked let's be good c plus
plus citizens and reset our pointers
after we delete so we're going to say p
number one equals no pointer and we are
going to be playing it safe here and
again we just lift memory here and it is
something you should avoid in your
programs if you run this program it is
going to run just fine so let's see that
because i don't want to leave you with
programs containing errors
if i run rooster again it's going to end
well but it is going to be leaking
memory here
so we don't want to leak memory avoid
this like a plague we're going to
comment this out
and show you that you can also leak
memory when you have some nested scopes
in your programs okay let's go down here
and put that in and here is a simple
example we have a nested scope nested
inside the main function and inside the
scope here we are setting up a new
pointer
and it is going to be pointing to
dynamically allocated memory and that
memory is going to contain a 57.
the only key we have to this dynamic
memory is this p number two pointer here
but this p number two pointer lives on
the stack itself so when the scope here
is going to end p number two is no
longer going to be accessible and the
memory is going to be linked if you
really want to play it safe you can go
do whatever you want with the dynamic
memory and when you are done with that
you can delete that piece of memory here
while you still have access to p number
two but if you don't
delete here
in the scope where this thing was
declared
if you hit the end of this scope you're
going to lose access to this pointer and
you will be losing access to this
dynamic piece of memory
and you're going to be leaking memory
because you're not deleting it even if
you want to delete it you won't be able
to do that because you don't have a key
that is going to lead you to that
dynamic memory so if we try and do
delete p number two here this is not
going to compile because we don't have
access to p number two p number two is
scoped inside this nested scope here
this is what i mean so be sure you are
aware of this memory leak problem the
cases we have seen here are really
extensive enough to give you an
intuition on how this is bad and you're
going to be avoiding this new programs
and you're going to be on your way to
become a better c plus plus developer
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture to learn about memory leads
show you a few examples of them i hope
now you understand them we are going to
stop here in this lecture and the next
one we're going to learn about
dynamically allocated arrays
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to look at
dynamic arrays and these are arrays you
can allocate on the heap and they're not
going to be stored on the stack like we
have seen before the arrays we have
learned about so far have been living on
the stack we want to see how we can
allocate arrays on the heap if we happen
to need that in our applications arrays
are allocated on the hip with the new
operator we can also use the sdd no
throw version of the new operator if we
don't want exceptions in our c plus plus
programs here is a simple example of how
you can do that we have a pointer called
p salaries it's going to be a pointer to
double and it is going to contain the
address to the dynamic memory that we
allocate on the heap which is going to
contain an array
of doubles of this size here okay this
is an array that is going to be
initialized with junk values because we
are not initializing that
explicitly so this is something you need
to be aware of okay p students is also
going to be containing the address of an
array that is going to be allocated on
the heap we are using the sdd nothro
version of the new operator because in
this case for example we might not want
exceptions and we're going to say that
it is an array of events it's going to
be this size but we are using breast
initializer so this is going to be
initialized to zero
all the values inside are going to be
initialized to zero this is what we mean
here we also have a p scores array we
are using the std no throw version of
new and it is going to be this size and
initialized with one two three four five
okay if
the array is bigger than five the
remaining slots are going to be
initialized with zeros just like we saw
with the arrays we have learned about
previously that we're stored on the
stack this is really how you work with
these things and i hope it is super
clear again we are calling the new
operator
this is going to allocate however memory
space is needed to store these things on
the heap so if this array is going to
contain 10 elements we're going to
allocate enough space to contain 10
double elements on the heap and we're
going to be pointing to that with the p
salaries pointer that's what we mean
here once you have your dynamic array
allocated on the hip you can try to do
things with it for example we can try
and loop through the squirrels and print
them out here you see that we are using
the angle bracket syntax and the
pointer arithmetic syntax it is going to
work equally well you can choose
whatever you want but i just wanted you
to see that you can use both versions
here the next logical thing to think
about when you talk about dynamic memory
allocation is how you release the memory
to the operating system when you're no
longer using it and this is the syntax
to do it with arrays you say delete you
put angle brackets and you say the
pointer that was used to allocate that
memory in the first place and after you
do that you have to remember to reset
the pointer to null pointer because you
are a good c plus plus citizen and this
is really all we had to say in this
lecture this is how you dynamically
allocate a raise on the hip before we
head over to visual studio code and play
with this though i want you to keep in
your mind that arrays you allocate
dynamically on the heap are very
different from the arrays that we have
learned about before and that's because
they don't work with std size and they
don't work for range based for loops
and that the reason for all these
limitations is that when you do
something like this the array really
decays into a pointer and it loses
information that would otherwise be used
to deduce the size that is used by sdd
size and there are other things that are
used by the range base for loop that
they lose when you store and refer to
them using a pointer like this that's
why we have this limitation keep this in
mind if you are using a dynamically
allocated array on the heap you're going
to be using other techniques to deduce
its size and it is not going to work
with a range base for loop so we will
have to use other kinds of loops that we
have learned about in this course and it
is going to work pretty well
this is really all i had to share in
this lecture now i think it's time we
went to visual studio code and actually
tried this out
here we are in our working folder the
current project is dynamically allocated
arrays
we are going to grab our template files
and put them in place
and we're going to put that in the
current project and open this in visual
studio code like we always do and we are
going to go down and put in some starter
code we can play with here we're going
to click on this
file icon to remove this pane
and we're going to try and show the code
here and again you see that visual
studio code is freaking out when it sees
the std no throw version of the new
operator here but it is going to work
when we hit the compiler okay so we are
allocating three arrays on the heap
dynamically and we are going to be
storing the addresses to these arrays
and these pointers for example p
salaries is going to store the address
to this dynamic array which is going to
be leaving on the heap and it is going
to be the same case for p students here
and p scores i don't think there is much
to explain here because we have already
learned about arrays we know about the
size of an array we know that it is a
piece of contiguous memory location that
is going to be storing variables of the
same type this is really what we're
going to have
so let's try and compile this and see
that it actually goes through our gcc
compiler and it is going to work fine
and another thing you should notice is
that this is really compiling even if
what we are using to store the size of
the array is not const remember for
stack arrays or static arrays that we
had on the stack
we had to make sure this guy here is
const
okay that was
a requirement and if you didn't fulfill
that your code wouldn't compile now you
see that with dynamic arrays the code is
actually compiling even if it's not cost
and this is something you should be
aware of let's build this again i just
messed up my things here
and the world is good if we go down and
run it we're not going to see anything
really because we're not having any
output in this program but this is how
you can allocate
space for a dynamic array on the heap
now let's try and print some of the data
in this course here let's go down here
and actually do that we are going to do
a no pointer check because we want to
make sure that memory was actually
allocated for the p scores array
and after we do that we're going to loop
for size times
and we're going to be printing whatever
element is at each iteration the index
at each iteration and you see that we
can either use the angle brackets
notation or the pointer arithmetic
notation it is going to work equally
well
if we built this
let's bring up our terminal we haven't
opened one and let's go down and clear
and run rooster
you're going to see that
successfully allocated
memory for scores
and we're going to be printing the data
first using the angle brackets notation
second using pointer arithmetic and you
see that it is working pretty well
one thing you should have noticed now is
that we haven't actually
released the memory that we have
allocated here and this is something
really bad so we're going to see how we
can do that we have allocated space for
salaries p students and scores so let's
go down and do that and we're going to
say delete
and we're going to have angular brackets
because this is an array we are
releasing memory for or to be exact a
dynamic array which was allocated on the
heap so we're going to say p
salaries
and we're going to reset that pointer
to no pointer because we are good c plus
plus citizens so we're going to do that
no pointer and we're going to do the
same thing delete
we are deleting
space for a dynamic array so the angle
brackets here
the square brackets i should say and we
are going to delete p students i think
yes so we're going to say p student
and we're going to say p students and
we're going to reset this to no pointer
and we're going to do the same for p
scores
let's grab this here that's what we want
no that's not what we want we're going
to say delete and say square brackets
ourselves and we're going to say p
scores and we're going to release that
and say p scores
and reset this to null pointer now we
are really playing it safe and our
program is going to release the memory
that we allocated in these three
statements here
if we build the program it is going to
go through well so we're going to build
with gcc
and we are going to clear
and run rooster and it is going to run
pretty well you see that for peace
corpse
we initialized the first five elements
and the remaining elements were
initialized
implicitly by the compiler to zero and
you can see that here i don't think i
explained this but this is my chance to
explain this i hope you understand the
next thing i wanted to explore before we
close this video is the difference
between static arrays and dynamic arrays
a static array is an array you allocate
on the stack like we have been doing
before and you do it using a syntax like
let's say scores why not and it is going
to be an array that says it is going to
contain 10 elements
and we are going to put in our values in
the format that we know
and we're going to go all the way to 10
let's put in a 10 here and we're going
to end this with a semicolon
this array is cool and you can loop
through it you can do all kinds of crazy
things with it but i am going to
emphasize two differences we have with
dynamic arrays one is that this guy is
going to work with sdd size so we're
going to say the out
okay this is going to work if we compile
this
we're going to get a good world at least
i hope yes the world is good and if we
run rooster
we're going to get scores the size is
10.
the other thing is that you can use a
range based for loop to loop through
this guy here so for example we can say
for
auto score s for score in scores
and it is going to work so let's go down
and say what we are doing here or we can
even say a single line to separate fence
here i don't want to be confused so i am
going to do something like this so that
i know where my output here is going to
start
so i am going to build this
with gcc of course the world is going to
go through
and if i clear
and run rooster
i am going to see that the size is 10
and i am going to print my elements here
with a range based for loop
okay let's see how these things behave
when we use a dynamic array we are going
to set up a similar array but on the hip
which is going to leave on the hip this
array here is the static array in that
it is going to live on the stack you
have to be aware of these differences
okay we're going to do another one which
is going to leave on the heap and the
way we do that we say end pointer let's
say p scores one to make sure this is
different from p squares that we have on
top here and we're going to have 10
elements inside and we can even
initialize this guy exactly like we are
doing here but the data is not going to
leave on the stack the data is going to
leave on the heap
if we do something like this first let's
make sure that the code compiles we're
going to try and run this
through gcc
and watch the compiler output here the
bolt is good so this is valid c plus
plus code
we can try and use hdd size on that and
we're going to go down and do that
and if we do that we're going to say p
scores size
one size and say p scores if we try to
pass this pointer here you're going to
see that visual studio code is going to
freak out because this won't work
the
array here has decayed into a pointer
when we refer to it using a row pointer
like this so we can't really use it
inside std size
so if we look at this we're going to get
a weird compiler error but this is going
to be the problem here
okay so you can't do this with dynamic
arrays this is one limitation the other
is that you can't use dynamic arrays
like we are using a range based for loop
here so if we grab this loop and try to
work with it on p scores for example
this is something somebody might want to
do
let's say
pscores1 okay and try to print something
inside you're going to see that this is
not going to work the compiler visuals
video code is not going to like it first
and if we try and run this through gcc
we're also going to get a weird compiler
arrow and the problem is going to be
that p scores is really not an array it
is just a pointer that is pointing to
some location in memory that's all it is
and it doesn't have information that
could be used otherwise to loop through
elements
like we can do for a real static array
that is leaving on the stack again let's
be super clear here and say that this
array is going to leave
on the heap you have to understand these
things but this is really not a big
limitation because you can store the
size of this guy in some variable and
refer to it if you need that and you can
loop through the array exactly like we
did here using size and it is going to
work pretty well so don't be afraid to
store your arrays on the heap if that's
what you need in your application it is
going to work pretty well you just have
to be aware of some limitations that
come with doing things this way here
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you have a better
idea about dynamic arrays you set them
up like this the size here doesn't have
to be cost like we have with static
arrays and they have a few differences
compared to static arrays that were
stored on the stack and that std size
doesn't work for them and they don't
work with range based for loops other
than that dynamic arrays are ridiculed
and you should use them when that helps
whatever it is you are designing
welcome to this new chapter where we are
going to be talking about references
references are a way you can set up
alliances for your variables and have
other variable names you can go through
to modify that same variable for example
here we have a variable called var it is
an integer it leaves at this address
here and the value inside is 33.
if we set up another alliance to it as
var elias we can go through this var
elias variable and use it in pretty much
the same way we use the original
valuable and this is going to come in
handy in many situations as we are about
to see in this chapter we are going to
start in the next lecture and see how we
can declare initialize and use
references in our c plus plus
applications
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to see
how we can declare and use references in
our c plus application again a reference
is an elias variable that you can use to
reference an original variable and use
that reference in pretty much the same
way you use the original variable let's
see how that can work in c plus plus
here is a simple example we have two
variables one is an integer we have 45 n
the other is a double we have 33.65
n
we want to set up references to this
variable and the syntax is ridiculously
easy
for the edge value its reference is
going to be something like ant ampersand
you put the ampersand symbol you say the
name of the reference and you initialize
this with the value in the variable that
you want this to reference so reference
to h value is going to be referencing
our integer here and we can use this
name to reference this variable here and
it is going to be like we are using the
original variable which is interval here
we're going to see how this works in a
minute we can do the same using
assignment initialization and down here
you see that we have an example for the
double value and we have a reference to
it once we have these references we can
use them like we use
the original variables for example if
you come here you see we are printing
stuff out if we print any value we're
going to get the value printed out if we
print double value we're going to get
the value printed out we can also print
through references you're going to see
that they are going to print exactly the
same value as we have in the original
variables
but the interesting thing is going to be
that
if you print the addresses through the
original values and print the addresses
through the references you're going to
get the same addresses printed out which
is really going to say this to variable
names are almost exactly the same thing
in c plus plus and this is really cool
you can use the reference as if you are
using the original variable name in your
c plus plus code we're even going to try
and go through the sizes and print them
out and you're going to see that they
are going to be exactly the same thing
and we are going to see how important
this can become in c plus plus code as
we go through this chapter okay now that
we have the reference declared we can go
through that and modify the value and if
we do that the changes are going to be
reflected in the original variables and
if we print stuff like this again we're
going to see that the changes are going
to be reflected in the original
variables okay if you modify the
original variable the changes are also
going to be reflected in our references
and this is exactly what we would expect
from our references okay so this is
really all there is about references
they are alliances to your variables and
you can use them pretty much the same
way you use your variables let's head
over to visual studio code and see some
of these things in action here we are in
our working directory the chapter is
references and the lecture is declaring
and using references we are going to
grab our template files here
and we're going to put them in place and
we are going to open this in visual
studio code we are going to set up a new
variable let's call this data or it's
data this is going to be much more
descriptive and we're going to
initialize this with a 33 why not and
we're going to do a double and say
double data and we're going to put in a
55 in
and we're going to set up references to
these variables
and again a reference is an elias that
you can use in pretty much the same way
you use the original variable so we're
going to set up a reference to int data
we're going to say
and
reference mean reference by putting the
ampersand symbol here and we're going to
say rough
and
yeah and you initialize that
with the variable name you want this
reference to reference
and uh here we want to reference into
data so we're going to pass in into data
and this is going to be it our reference
is declared we can do the same for
double data so let's do that
double and we're going to say it's a
reference we're going to say rough
double data and we're going to reference
devo data here so let's do that okay
let's bring up our terminal and see if
we can compile this code here we're
going to compile with gcc like we always
do and let's close this then on the left
because it takes up
some of the space here the world is good
so this syntax is valid c plus plus
syntax
so what we can do is read values from
all these things and show you that they
really are the same things so we're
going to print stuff out and i am going
to put here some code and i am going to
come back when i have typed this i don't
want you to suffer watching me type
these things okay here i have the code
type down and you see that i am just
going to print dana through the original
variables i am going to print the actual
data and print the address of the
variable and do the same for the debo
data which is of type double
how convenient and we're going to print
references we're going to print the
reference and the address of the
reference and we're going to do the same
thing for our ref devil data here let's
try and build this with gcc
so we're going to run the task to do
that
and we are going to clear the book is
good and run rooster if we run rooster
you see that let's put a separate end
line here so that we see the entire
thing so
i really like to see my fans easily
so let's do that and build again okay
the build is good we can clear and run
rooster now and we're going to see the
original data and data is 33 the address
is this guy here we have demo data the
value is 55 and this is the address if
we look at our references we have
exactly the same thing the addresses are
even the same it really is like we are
using the original variable and this is
really cool it can allow you to pass
data around much easily
using references and whatever you are
using when you have sent this data for
example to some other file or some other
function you're going to be
affecting the same data okay so you're
not going to be making copies and we're
going to see how cold this can be
especially when we get to working with
functions this is going to be super cool
okay now we have seen that the
references are really referencing the
original values let's try and modify the
data through
the original values and see that the
references are going to pick up the
changes let's do that we're going to
take 80 data and change that to
111 and we're going to take the apple
data and change that to 67.2
why not and after we do this we're going
to print data again so we're going to
grab the code here
and
use that again here and we should see
the same changes applied
so we're going to weld with dcc the bolt
is going to be good
as you see here and if we clear and run
rooster
we are going to see that
the value is 55 let's put a separation
line in here this is cramped and it is
really hard to see what is happening
here so i am going to put an std endl in
here and weld again so let's do that and
the book is good so we can clear and run
rooster again and now we see things
separated out and it is easier on the
eye here we have empty data to b33 and
the depot data is 55 and we are going to
print our references which are going to
pick up the same things because a
reference is really analyzed to
the original variables but if you go
down you're going to see that the data
has actually changed and together has
changed to 111
and nabodana has changed to 67.2
and the interesting thing is that the
references have also picked up those
changes because they really are
referencing the same things in memory
it's like we are using the original
variable to
read these things like we are doing with
references here and this is really cool
here we have used the original variables
to modify data but we can also modify
the data through references and the
original variables are going to pick up
those changes so let's do that we're
going to say ref data and we're going to
change this to
12 for example
and let's use
1014 or 12. this is going to do we're
going to do ref double data and put in
another large number let's say 1000.45
why not and we're going to print the
data again so we're going to grab
this and print stuff out again so we're
going to go down and put in the code to
print stuff and you see it's going to
use the original variables and the
references and we should see the changes
reflected in our terminal here
so let's do that
and we're going to weld with gcc as we
always do
the bullet is going to be cool we're
going to clear and run rooster we're
going to see that we have 33 and 55 the
references are going to pick that up
that's what we have here we're going to
put in
111 and 67 through the original
variables and the references are going
to be picking that up and we're going to
use references and modify data you see
that the original variables are also
picking that up because we are really
modifying data in the same memory
location that's why these changes are
being shared between references and the
original variables and this is really
all we set out to do in this lecture to
show you how you can set up a reference
and prove that the changes we do either
through original data or references are
reflected between these two guys meaning
references and the original
variables
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
do a comparison between pointers and
references because they seem to be doing
quite the same thing
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there and this lecture we're
going to be looking at the similarities
and the differences between references
and pointers okay we know that a pointer
is really something that is going to
store the address of the variable and we
can go through that pointer and modify
the original variable or really do
things with that but in the last lecture
we saw that we could also do the same
thing with references so why have these
two mechanisms in place
and what are the differences between
them here is a simple slide that i put
together to put the important points
about references and pointers together
the first thing is that if you use
references you are not going to go
through the star symbol to the reference
and get to the value you are
manipulating so that's going to really
feel like you are using the original
variable but with pointers you are going
to go through the referencing so that's
the first difference
another thing about references is that
you can't change them to reference
something else later but with pointers
we saw that we could do that we can
change a pointer to point somewhere else
if it happens to be a non-const pointer
the other thing is that for references
you have to initialize them at
declaration you can't declare a
reference and not initialize that if you
do that you're going to get a compiler
error and we're going to see that in a
minute but for pointers you can declare
a pointer and not initialize it and it
is going to just contain a junk address
and if you try to use that uninitialized
you are going to be setting yourself up
for trouble so we saw that so these are
the main differences between pointers
and references and now we are just going
to be looking at how these translate in
code here is a simple example we have a
variable called double value which
happens to be double and we have a
reference to it and a pointer to it so
you already know these concepts
now if we want to read the value in here
through our pointer and references we're
going to be using two different syntaxes
if we go through the reference we can
use this reference variable name
directly and read the value or change it
and we can do something like
ref double value to print that out this
is going to work but if we want to go
through the pointer we will have to go
through the referencing and this is
really bad
you know sometimes people don't like
this syntax they think that it is not
direct enough so they prefer to use
references to do these kinds of things
but pointers are still important as we
will see later as we progress in the
course so this is one difference with
references you don't have to go through
the dereferencing mechanism to use this
star here to print stuff or even
manipulate the data inside you just use
the variable name and it is going to
work with pointers you have to reference
because if you don't the reference
you're going to be referring to the
address stored in this pointer this is
the first difference and we see that the
same applies if we are trying to
write data into our variable if we go
through the pointer we will have to
dereference and use this dollar symbol
in front here
if we are using a reference we can do
that directly as if we are modifying the
original variable so this syntax is much
more readable the other difference is
that we can't make a reference
reference something else but we can
change a pointer to point to something
else let's look at an example here we
have ref double value which is a
reference to double value
and here
we are doing an assignment to this thing
here we are saying either double value
and assigning that
to our reference but what we are doing
here is not making ref double value
reference this other variable we are
just grabbing the value in other double
value and assigning that to our
reference and the value in either double
value is going to be reflected in the
original value here so this is what we
are doing we are not reassigning to our
reference to make it reference something
else we are assigning the value to the
reference as it is now and it is going
to be still referencing the same
variable in memory if you print out the
address in memory you're going to see
that the address of the reference here
hasn't changed so this is something you
should keep in mind but we know that a
pointer can point somewhere else if we
have a pointer here for example p double
value we can reassign it another address
and make it point to that new address so
in this regard we can think of
references as cost pointers because cost
pointers can't also be made to point
somewhere else and if you're trying to
do that for example here we have a cost
pointer it is called cost p double value
and if we try and make it point
somewhere else through this assignment
here we're going to get a compiler error
okay so this is really all in terms of
the comparisons that we had to make
between references and pointers now
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and see how these things
work in real code so here we are in our
working folder the current project is
comparing pointers and references we are
going to grab our template files and put
them in place
and we are going to open this project in
visual studio code like we always do we
are going to go down and put in some
starter code and let's align this a
little better
so and we can close this pane so that we
have some breathing room here we have a
variable of double type and we set up a
reference to it and a pointer to it this
is how we do this thanks you already
know this
and we can try and read through
the original variable through the
reference and through the pointer and
see how these syntaxes differ and how
one might be better than the other for
example if we look at how we are using
the reference it's really like we are
using the original value here we don't
have to do reference if we try to print
the pointer directly like this without
the referencing this is going to print
the actual address stored in this
pointer it's not going to print the
actual value stored in the address
pointed to by this pointer i really want
this to be clear so this is the syntax
we can use for reading stuff either
through references or pointers we can
also use these syntaxes to write stuff
into our variables for example here we
can go through the pointer and we have
to the reference and we can go through
the reference to really do the same
thing and we're going to see that our
syntaxes here are going to pick up the
changes
regardless of whether we write through
pointer or a reference because all these
things really are going to be
referencing the same location in memory
let's try and bring up a terminal here
and we are going to world with gcc let's
do that the build is going to be good
and we're going to clear and run rooster
and you're going to see that at first
we're going to have a 12
point 34 in
that's going to be the value we can get
it through original value the reference
or the pointer through the referencing
and the address is this one here
if we change the value through the
pointer we're going to see the changes
reflected here and if we change the
value through the reference we're going
to see the changes reflected in here so
this is how you can use pointers and
references to do these things here and
you can really choose what makes sense
for your application they mostly do the
same things but some people say that the
syntax to the reference the pointer here
is really ugly that's why most people
prefer to use references like this but
references have other benefits as well
as we're going to see as we progress in
the course another thing i want you to
see is that you can't change a reference
to reference something else in memory
for example here we have our reference
which is ref double value if we try and
make it reference something else
we're not going to get that result let's
go down and try to do that
so we're going to set up another double
variable so if we try to
make our ref double value reference this
guy
the syntax that comes to mind is saying
ref
double value and assign that the some
other
double value here now let's see what
happens if we do that we're going to try
and print whatever we have in memory
using the
ref double value here let's grab this
and go down here and say that we are
changing the reference making the
reference reference something else let's
say that so if we try to build this
let's see what we get we're going to run
and build with gcc
and we're going to try and run this
clear not clear and we're going to run
rooster
we're going to see that
the last line of output here say 78.45
but the address is still the same so we
are still referencing the same memory
with our reference and what we just did
here was just grab the value in some
other double value
and assign that in here but the
reference is referencing the same memory
location it's been referencing so in c
plus plus you don't have a way you can
go through
to make a reference reference something
else the only chance you have to make it
reference something is through
declaration here and that's the reason
you can't declare a reference and not
initialize it if you do that you're
going to get a compiler error so let's
try and do something like this we're
going to take out this double value and
the moment we do this you're going to
see that visual studio code is going to
be unhappy you see the squiggly line and
it is going to say initial value of
reference to non-cos must be an l value
so what is that
okay if we take out the initialization
altogether it's going to give us a
better error i think reference variable
requires an initializer so every time
you declare a reference you have to
initialize it and we should do like we
just did before here and we're going to
be fine again you can't declare a
reference and not initialize it if you
do that you're going to get a compiler
error and the reason is that
this is the only shot you get to make
your reference reference something else
okay if there was a way for you to
bypass this and let the compiler compile
this you would never get another chance
to make this guy actually reference
something and it would really be a
useless reference so make sure you
understand this you can't make a
reference reference something else and
if you try to do something through a
syntax like this
you're going to be assigning the value
of whatever variable you have to the
reference you're not going to be making
the reference referencing something else
the reference is going to keep
referencing the same variable in memory
as we have seen here so let's say what
we were trying to do here but we know
that we can make pointers reference
something else so here we have a pointer
again
this pointer called the p double value
and it has the address of double value
inside
but we can set up another variable
okay so we can make that reference this
other variable here and let's do that
you're going to see that our pointer now
is going to be containing another
address so what we can do
is say p double value
which is our new pointer and we're going
to assign it
the address of some other double value
and if we print the data now and go down
we are going to say make the pointer
point to something else that's what we
are doing here and we're going to say
the same thing here through a comma and
if we print this try to guess what we're
going to get
the pointer is going to contain a
completely new address because we can do
that we can make it point
to somewhere else
let's run rooster
and we're going to see our data here
let's make sure we see the entire fan
okay i think this is the data we have
let's go up again
there's no harm in that so we have our
fence that we have seen before but what
is going to be important here is that pw
value now contains a new address
okay so this is really important and you
have to understand that so we made the
pointer successfully point to something
else and if we change the data in the
pointer now
we're not going to be affecting the data
we have in here in double value we're
going to be affecting the data we have
and some other double value here let's
do that we're going to change the data
through the pointer so we're going to
say p double value and we're going to
change this to
and now we can print the data and see
that things have changed in memory and
we can print this to see the differences
here but before we do that let's also
print the address of the original
variable and the address because for now
we are just printing only the address
through the pointer so what we can do
here is grab htdc out and say
address of double volume and we're going
to put that out through htdc out here
we're going to do that and we're going
to print the address of the reference
why not
ref double value and we're going to put
that out as well i'm going to say
address of ref
double value
and we're going to say std endn and
after that we are going to grab the
entire thing here and print it out after
we modify the value in the pointer
i hope this is going to show thanks in a
much more
clear way so we're going to weld this
with gcc let's do that the build is good
so let's clear and run rooster and what
you're going to see is that
now
the original variable is living at
address here
which we can see in our reference but
the pointer now is pointing to something
else
no wonder that the changes we did
through the pointer are not being
reflected in our double value because
these two variables now
are living in different memory locations
i really hope you see that and this is
really all we had to share in terms
of the differences between pointers and
references i hope you have a clear
picture of what these two things are and
we are going to stop here in this
lecture this one we're going to see how
the const key world works with
references
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to see
how the const key world can be used with
references
and again the idea is to set up an alias
to a variable and make it const so that
we can't go through it to modify the
original variable this is the syntax we
used to set up a non-const reference
that we have seen so far so for example
we can say int age put in a value 27 in
this case and set up a reference to age
and initialize that
with the age variable once we do this
riff edge can be used to modify
this edge variable here and whatever is
inside for example we can go through ref
age to increment the age and if we print
the edge now we should get a 28 printed
out because this reference is going to
change these two things at the same time
or another way to say this these two
things age and ref age are referencing
the same memory
in your computer so if you change one
the other is going to pick up the change
we can also set up accounts reference
and the syntax is ridiculously easy you
say constant reference like this and
your reference is suddenly caused and
you can't go through it to modify the
original variable
if you need something like this in your
application this is how you do it you
can also duplicate the behavior with
count references with pointers and for
that we can use a construct like const
end pointer cost this is going to set up
a cost pointer to cost which we can't
use to modify the value that we are
pointing to
but it can't also be used to point to
something else so this is going to
simulate the behavior we have with
references and you can do that if you
want and please know that we have no
such thing as constant reference cost
this is going to give you a compiler
error because we have no such concept in
c plus plus and my head is hurting right
now trying to think about what this
would even mean and another thing i want
to make clear before we head over to
vg's video code and play with us is that
the const key world is going to apply to
the variable name
that you apply it to for example here we
have cost reference age which is going
to be a const reference but this doesn't
mean that the edge variable here has to
be cost
okay it can be cost or it may not be
cost but the cost here applies to this
variable name constraint age and we
can't go through this variable name and
modify the age if you're trying to do
that we're going to get a compiler error
now we can head over to visual studio
code and play with us here we are in our
working directory the current project is
reference and cost we're going to grab
our template files pretty quick let's do
that
and we're going to put them in place
and we are going to open this in visual
studio code we are going to review the
references we have seen so far in this
little example here we have the edge
variable it has a 27 inside and it is a
net and we have a reference to it
and this reference is not const so we
can go through this reference modify the
age and if we do that this is going to
work and if we print the edge here we're
going to see that it has turned into a
28 and we can try and print this through
the terminal so that you can see this
for yourself so let's run the task to
build with gcc
we are going to clear
and run rooster
and if we do that you're going to see
edge is 27 now it is 28 and we have
successfully modified data through our
reference here
but if we change this reference to be
const we won't be able to do that
anymore so let's try and make it a const
reference
if we do that we're going to get a
compiler error if we try to do something
like this because this is now a const
reference we can't go through it to
modify our data here and we're going to
get a compiler error here we have visual
studio called complaining here but if we
ignore that and go through the compiler
we're going to see that we get the same
compiler error we can't implement a read
only reference which is this ref age
here so this is what a cost reference
really is you can't go through it to
modify the data that is being referenced
and another thing i want you to really
understand is that this const keyword
here has nothing to do with the original
variable this is a constant reference we
can't go through it to modify the edge
variable but this doesn't matter if age
is either const or not const the
constants here applies to this variable
name here so this cost h may be cost if
it's cost it's going to work equally
well and we're going to still get a
compiler error here if it's not cost
it's going to be the same the cost we
have on our reference applies to this
reference variable name here this is
what i want you to understand okay this
is what a cost reference really is
another thing we want you to see
is that we can simulate the same
behavior
with pointers so let's set up a const
pointer to const on this edge here and
we're going to see that we can have the
same behavior but for that we're going
to have to comment this out because we
don't want noise output and we're going
to go on top here and comment this out
and say what we are intending to do we
can say that we are simulating reference
behavior with pointers and the way we're
going to do that we're going to say
const and pointer cost and we're going
to say ph
and we're going to initialize this with
our age variable or the address of our
age to be super clear okay so we have
our pointer set up let's try and go
through it and modify the age let's see
what happens we the reference because
this is a pointer and we're going to say
ph and say plus plus or even change this
to another age let's say 45 and if we do
this we're going to get the same
compiler error so if we build this
let's clear here clear not clear
and above again we're going to get
another compiler error saying that we
can't modify something that is read only
assignment of read only location this
pointer can't be used to modify the data
in this age location here so this is the
same behavior with references because
the reference by default can't be made
to point somewhere else we had to make
this pointer also a const pointer
preventing us from making it point to
other locations so this is how you can
simulate references with pointers and
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture i hope you found it
interesting
the main idea was to let you know how
you can work with cost references and
once you have your const reference you
can't go through it to modify the
original data if you do that you're
going to get a compiler error
welcome to this new chapter where we
will be doing cool stuff with text data
we have seen that we can model a
character array and store in a bunch of
characters and we could for example call
this character array message and
manipulate it in memory in this
structure we will see that this is
actually the way text data is stored in
c plus plus and we have a lot of
facilities built on top of this
character already construct to make it
easy to work with text data we will see
that we can use character arrays to
model c strings which are a facility we
use in c plus plus to handle text data
and we will see that there are a few
built-in facilities we can use to
manipulate that we can get the length of
a string we can concatenate strings and
put them together we can copy strings we
can search for data inside strings we
can do all kinds of crazy things but we
will see that c strings are not that
easy or convenient to work with for
example you need to keep track of how
big the string is in memory you need to
also remember to make sure it ends
correctly and we will see the details
about that in this chapter long story
short c strings are not safe or
convenient to work with in c plus plus
and c plus plus provide another type
that really builds on top of character
arrays but it gives us an easier
interface to work with and we can just
focus on storing in the data and doing
stuff with it in our c plus programs and
the big idea about what we're going to
be doing in this chapter is learn about
the facilities we have in c plus plus to
handle text data in our c plus plus
programs in the next lecture we're going
to start and show you how you can
manipulate
individual characters in a character
array
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to be
learning about some facilities in the c
plus plus standard library
that can help us manipulate characters
and here are a few things you might want
to do with those facilities for example
you might want to know if a character is
alphanumeric or if it's a number or a
character you might want to know if it
is alphabetic you might want to know if
it's a blank character you might want to
know if it's a lowercase or uppercase
character depending on what you want to
do in your application of course there
are facilities to check if characters
are digits there are even those that
help us you know transform characters
make them lowercase or uppercase and
we're going to see
these examples here all of these are
documented at
cppreference.com so you can go there and
find the documentation here is the same
link opened in my browser you see that
they leave in the cc type library so you
need this included if you want to use
them and you see that there is quite a
bunch of them we are going to cover just
a section of them and i will leave you
to use the documentation if you need to
use any more of these guys our first
example here is going to help us check
if a character is alpha numeric and the
function we're going to use from the c
plus plus standard library is std is l
num
and you just pass it a parameter of a
character and it's going to tell you if
a character is either alphanumeric or if
it's not if it is alphanumeric you're
going to get a value that is different
from zero which can be treated like a
true if it's not you're going to get a
value that you can treat like a zero and
how do i know this well we can check the
documentation so if i come back to our
link here
and there is a function here is i'll num
i can open it in another tab and it is
going to tell me what this function does
checks if the given character that you
pass as a parameter here is an
alphanumeric character as classified by
the current siluca
so
it's going to tell us if the character
is
alphanumeric or not you give it a
character and what you get from it is
the return value here it's going to
return a non-zero value if the character
is alpha numeric so this non-zero value
which is an integer because that's what
we get out of this function is going to
be treated like a true
and if this character here is not alpha
numeric we're going to get zero that we
can treat like a false this is really
cool and if you go down here you're
going to find a few examples i don't
want you to worry about this c local
thing
it is a
setting that allows you to
say more about the meaning of the
characters that you are storing in
memory but for now we're just going to
be happy with the defaults and use this
function as is it is going to work
enough well okay here is our function
again so here c is alphanumeric we
expect to get a value
different from zero because c is
alphanumeric and the second example here
is not alphanumeric so we expect to get
a value that is equal to zero and we can
use the return of this function
in a test for example we can say a
character we put in a star here it is
called input car and we say f is al num
and we pass this character we're going
to print out this character is alpha
numeric if it's not we're going to print
is not alpha numeric you can do that and
you can do all kinds of crazy tests in
your c plus plus applications here is
another example that we can use to know
if the character is alphabetic so it's
going to return a value different from
zero if the character is a an alphabet
character a through z that's going to
return something different from zero and
if we pass something that is not for
example
this second line here or the seven at
the third line here we're going to get a
value equal to zero because that's not
alphabetic we have another facility to
help check if a character is a black
character and we see an example that
here we have a character array called
message we have a couple of blanks
inside and we can hunt for them using
the ease blank facility from the c plus
plus standard library here we have a
variable that is going to keep track of
how many black characters are in here it
is initialized to zero and we're going
to loop around okay and we're going to
look by the amount equal to the size of
the message array here we can use std
size again because this is a row array
it is a static array and we can use sdd
size it is going to give us how many
characters we have in this array you
already know this and if we get inside
we are going to try and check and see if
the current character
is a blank if it is we're going to print
that out and we're going to increment
our blank account by the time this loop
is done we will have printed out a lot
of blank characters if we happen to
have them in our message and at the end
we're going to say in total we found
however many blank characters this is
what we're going to see
if we run this program and hopefully you
can see how useful
this can be in text processing
applications if that happens to be what
you are working on we're going to run
this example in visual studio code in a
minute here is another example that we
can use to check if a character is
uppercase or
lowercase we have an array of characters
here inside we have some text
and we have a few variables to keep
track of how many characters are
lowercase or uppercase we're going to
set up a loop which is going to be a
range based for loop and we know that
through std is lower
we're going to increment the lowercase
count if it is uppercase we're going to
increment the uppercase count this is
how we can do this
and we are going to print that
information when the loop here is done
okay we still have a few examples ahead
the current one is going to check if a
character is a digit if you want to do
that you can use this and we have a
character array here and we're going to
have for digits inside this message here
so we're going to do basically the same
thing we're going to set up a variable
that is going to keep track of how many
digits we have in this message we are
going to loop around using a range based
for loop we're going to check if the
current character is a digit and we're
going to
increment
our variable here if it happens to be
the case and at the end we're going to
say how many digits we found in our
message here it is this simple the last
example we're going to look at is to
help us turn a character into lowercase
or uppercase and here is an example that
is going to help us play with us we're
going to have a
character array called home the feeling
of belonging and we will set up a
destination character array
that we're going to store whatever we
want to set up in
here you see a loop that is going to
turn our message here into uppercase
and you see we're going to loop around
by this amount the size of original
strength
and we're going to be grabbing each
character at each iteration
and turning that to uppercase this is
what std to upper function does the
result of that is going to be stored in
our destination string and by the time
we are done here original string is
going to be however it was but uppercase
string is going to be stored in our
destination array and if we print it out
we should see this thing printed in
uppercase we can basically do the same
thing and turn the string into lowercase
and our destination string is going to
be now lowercase and you're going to see
that this works out pretty well
now that you have a basic understanding
about how these things work we're going
to head over to vg studio code and play
with us okay here we are in our working
directory the current project is
character manipulation
we are going to grab our template files
like we always do and we're going to put
this in place and we're going to open
this in visual studio code pretty quick
and we are going to go down and put in
our first example this example is going
to be using the std is al num facility
and this is going to be checking if the
character is alpha numeric we're going
to see what we get from this if we print
this out we're going to check if c the
character c is alphanumeric we're going
to see what we get and we're going to
check if this character here i don't
know how to pronounce it i'm sorry
we're going to check if it is
alpha numeric we're going to see that
and we're going to use this in at
condition we're going to check and see
if our star character here is
alphanumeric and we're going to print
that out we're going to say it is alpha
numeric or it is not from the
documentation we know that this thing
lives in the cctype
library so we may want to include that
but it is possible that it is coming
from iostream here that's why we don't
see
visual studio code complaining here as
an example if we try and comment out
this include here
you're going to see that
this is not going to make sense anymore
okay so the include needed to use these
guys here is coming from io stream okay
so we're not going to include that here
we are going to open up a terminal
and build this with gcc and you're going
to see that the block is good if we go
down and clear let's clear properly and
run rooster we're going to see that c is
alphanumeric because we have a one the
one can be treated like a true and the
character here is not alphanumeric
because the result is zero
and you see that the star here is also
not alpha numeric and we know this
through our test here and you see that
we can do things like this
with this facility here if you want to
get true or false from this function you
can turn this into booleans using static
cast but we're not going to do that here
you already know that we can comment
this out for now and look at another
facility from the
cctype library there are many of these
we're going to look at quite a few of
them we're going to comment this out and
go down and put in a code here and this
is going to check if a character is
alphabetic so if it is an alphabet
character
a from z lowercase and uppercase
c is alphabetic the character here is
not alphabetic and seven here is not
alphabetic so for the first one here
we're going to get something
not equal to zero we should get a one
that's what they use in most cases for
this we're going to get a zero the
second one and for the third one we're
going to also get a zero this is what we
expect
we are going to build with gcc of course
and we are going to clear and run
rooster
and we're going to get that c is
alphabetic this guy is not alphabetic
and seven is not alphabetic if we change
this c to uh
e for example lowercase
and both again you're going to see that
the results are going to be what we
expect e is alphabetic
let's clear and run rooster this is
going to be exactly what we expect but
you see that it is not a one and this is
not guaranteed to always give you a one
it is guaranteed to give you something
different from zero if the character is
alphabetic and zero if not and we can
use this guy here in a test
for example
we can say f sdd is alpha and if we're
boiled the both is going to be good and
we're going to clear and run rooster and
you see e is alphabetic i should put a
space here i do encourage you to change
these characters up and see what you get
here and see how you can use this that's
in tests that's the best way to learn
okay before we continue i do encourage
you to try and run these methods through
different compilers for example here we
also have an msvc compiler from
microsoft setup so we can use that and
try to build this thing here but before
we do that let's bring up our pen here
and remove
rooster.exe here because
we don't want to override it we're going
to select it and do delete
and i am going to remove this and move
that to the recycle bin
and i am going to clear whatever i have
here on the terminal
and i am going to go there i am going to
choose run task
and i am going to choose world with msvc
here
i am going to use that it is going to
build my thang you see the output here
and we have rooster.exe here
and it should say that the world is good
in a minute world finished successfully
microsoft is going to give us a lot of
output here but no problem the build is
good
if we go in
we can actually check
and see what we have
in our folder here you're going to see
that we have these files one of them is
rooster.exe
if we run it we are going to get the
outputs that we expect and you see that
it is exactly the same thing we got
with gcc
i am telling you to try and use
different compilers because some
compilers are going to flat some of the
facilities from cctype
or those that start with c as unsafe
because there are some tanks that can
really throw you off about them and
we're going to learn about them in this
chapter as we move forward just know
that it is a good idea to try these
things on different compilers and see
the errors you get and make yourself
familiar with those things
for now we're going to move on and we
are going to keep using
gcc because that's my favorite compiler
you can use whatever compiler you want
the next example is going to check if
the character is blank let's close this
thing
and clear
and give ourselves some breathing room
we're going to bring this down a little
bit and we're going to check if the
character is blank the facility for that
is std is blank
and if it's a blank character we're
going to get something different than
zero and we can use that in a test like
this and if it's not a black we're going
to get something equal to zero and this
test here is going to fail so what this
example here is going to do it's going
to count how many blank characters we
have in this
message here and we're going to print
the counter of that on the console using
this line here so let's go through this
loop and see what it does the first
thing we do is initialize blank count to
0 and we are using an integer and
because this is a count i think blank
count is of wrong type because it can be
negative so to really be safe in our
program here we should make this
unsigned or even use size t
this is better okay so let's use size
t
because this is a size and size t is a
good type to keep track of sizes in your
c plus plus programs so make sure you
size t here
and what we're going to do
is go in the loop at each iteration
we're going to check if each character
at each iteration is a blank if it is
we're going to fall in here and say that
we found a blank character at this index
in our array here
and we're going to increment our blank
account and by the time this loop is
done we're going to have the blank
account stored in this blank account
variable and we're going to print that
out it is this simple
now we can build with gcc let's do that
we're going to world with our gcc
compiler
and the world is going to be good can
clear
and run rooster
and you're going to see that
it's going to say we found a blank
character at index 5
12 20 24 31 35 39 and 42
and in total we have found nine blank
characters do we have that many let's
count so one one blank character
we have two here we have three we have
four
we have five
here
we have six
seven
eight and nine if you count you're going
to find that we have them and the first
one is at index five so index zero is h
one two three four the first one is at
index five and this is doing exactly
what we want we can go down and check if
a character is uppercase or lowercase we
can do that through an example like this
and the facility is going to be std
lower and std is upper we have a message
here
we're going to loop around using a range
based for loop and we're going to check
if each character is either lowercase or
uppercase
and if the test is good we're going to
jump in the loop and we're going to
increment lowercase count which are a
few variables to keep track of how many
uppercase and lowercase characters we
have in here and again these variables
are going to store counts so it is
better
to use a size t or some unsigned integer
type but now we're going to use size t
because it is good so we're going to
keep this stored in here and we're going
to build this and see what we get
before we run we want to clear
and we are going to build with gcc
the bolt is going to be good we're going
to clear and run rooster
and you see that the original strand is
this guy here what we're going to do
we're going to print whatever character
we are at i'm going to put a space in
front of that and we're going to see
increment this is the output why do we
have this method here because we are
printing out
each character and we are not printing
the upper case ones we are printing
lowercase ones that's why you see
this guy here this is really interesting
you can keep this in if you want i am
going to keep this on the important
message is that we found lowercase
characters and uppercase characters and
we have five uppercase characters if we
go in and count we're going to find that
we have t here one
two and three and four and five five
uppercase characters and if you count
the lowercase characters one by one i am
sure that you're going to get a 47 like
we did here we're going to comment this
out because this was just an example
i am leaving this in here so that you
can use this as a reference if you want
we can also check if a character is a
digit
and we're going to use std is digit to
check that the return type is going to
be different from zero
if the test succeeds if it fails we're
going to get a zero and we can use that
like this so we have a message here
stored in the character array called
statement
and we're going to loop around checking
if each character we are at is actually
a digit or not if it's a digit we're
going to say found a digit i'm going to
say whatever digit we found and we're
going to increment the digits count and
we're going to store that information in
this digit count variable here we don't
want to make it an end so we're going to
make it a size t
and we're going to build and run this
program
and see how many digits we found you
know it is this number here i'm not
going to say it
we're going to let our program figure
this out so rooster and we're going to
find two two and one so we found three
digits and it is exactly what we expect
here
we're going to comment this out and show
you another example and in the last
example we're going to be showing you
that you can change the case of a
character if it's lowercase make it
uppercase if it's uppercase make it
lowercase and you can do things like
that we have a message here stored in
our character array called original str
we set up another array which is going
to store our message that is transformed
and we're going to loop around turning
everything we come across uppercase
the way we do that we're going to say
std to upper
and we're going to pass in the character
that we want to turn to uppercase if we
do that we're going to get an uppercase
character out of that and we're going to
store that in our destination
array at this index here it is this
simple after that we're going to print
the original strand and the uppercase
string we should get that printed out
because it is stored
in destination string here
and we're going to do the reverse and
turn that back into lowercase
we're going to grab the original
strength loop over it and at each
iteration we're going to get whatever we
have
and turn that to uppercase to lowercase
i should say
and the result of that is going to be
stored back in our destination strand so
we're going to overwrite whatever we
have in our destination string here and
after that we're going to branch the
lowercase string and we should get that
printed out this is how the example
works and if you have any problem
understanding this i am always around
please do ask i will do the best i can
to help you out for now we are going to
build this
with gcc the builder is going to be good
we're going to clear and we're going to
run booster and we're going to see that
the message is here it is turned
uppercase it is turned lower case and
this is how you can do these things here
so we have looked at a few of this
facilities from cctime i don't really
want to look at all of them because that
would be really boring i hope you have
an idea about how they work and if you
want to look at all of them all you have
to do is come to the documentation here
choose one
open it up and look at the documentation
and in most cases they are going to have
examples down here that you can look at
and play with
for now we are going to stop here in
this lecture this is really all we set
out to do to play with many of these
facilities from the cctype library in
the next lecture we're going to look at
how we can manipulate c strings and by
that we mean concatenating them or
putting them together copying them out
and doing all kinds of crazy things
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to look at
the facilities from the c plus plus
standard library to play with c strings
all of these are going to be leaving in
the c string library you can go and
check it out at cpp reference and we're
going to start and look at a few
examples of some of the things we can do
with this library i mean c string the
first thing we're going to look at is an
example of how we can check the length
of a strength here we have a character
array called message one it is a
character array and you see that we made
it const we also have another array that
is pointed to by pointer you know that
if we do things like this this array is
going to decay into a pointer and there
are a few things we can do with that for
example we can't use it with std size
and we can't use a range based for loop
to loop through this message to thank
you
but
sdr then is going to help us check the
length of this thing here so we can use
it for example if we do hdd sdr lam
message one we're going to get the
number of characters
in this
string here this is not going to count
the null character though so the null
character that is implicitly added in by
the compiler is not going to be counted
in here you're going to see this in a
minute when we hit visual studio code to
play with this thanks but this facility
can work regardless of whether you are
using a row array like this or even for
pointers like this and it is really cool
so we can use it like this we're going
to get it printed out please note that
we can also use the size of operator to
get the same thing so it is going to
work almost the same way but the size of
operator is going to include the null
character you need to be aware of this
the good thing about str lan here is
that it still works for a decade arrays
so if we use it on message 2 we're going
to get
the correct output we're going to get
the number of characters in here which
is really cool
and we can also try and print out the
size of
message two but here we're going to get
the size of a pointer printed out okay
that's how hdr lan works it lets you
evaluate the length of a strand here is
another example and it is str cmp or
string compare it is used to compare
strings what you're going to do with
this facility is give it two strands c
strands we should be exact
and one is this guy here l h ace or left
hand string i think that's what this
stands for and we're going to give it a
right hand strand and by the way these
signatures are copied straight from the
documentation so that we can look at
this in one slide to make it really easy
to follow this is going to return a
negative value if the first guy happens
to come before
the second guy in lexicographical order
so it is something like a comes in front
of b c comes in front of d or something
like that if the two strands are equal
it is going to return
zero and it's going to return a positive
value
if the first guy appears after the
second guy
okay and we're going to try it out we
have two strings alabama and la bama
here and they are stored in character
arrays that are pointed to by these two
pointers string data one and string data
two and we can do something like this
below here so we're going to print
something out
and we're going to say std string
compare and we're going to pass in the
first string and the second string for
now i want you to pause a little bit and
try to guess what we're going to get
printed out here
the first string is alabama the second
one is blah blah so the first one comes
in front of the second
and we see that we're going to get a
negative value if the first guy comes in
front of the second guy so alabama comes
in front of blabama
and we would expect to get something
negative from this thing we are doing
here
and again if we try and change them up a
little bit you see that alabama still
comes before a la bomb
so we're going to get a negative value
pointed out and we can change these
things up to see what we get it is
really simple if you know how to use
them we can also use another version of
string compare which is going to let us
specify the number of characters that we
want to compare
we can specify that we want to compare n
characters in this case it is three
characters and it is going to compare a
section of the strings that you specify
as a first and second parameter here so
for example if we change string that i
want to be a a i a and string data two
to b a a a n c a and we are comparing
three characters in here so we are
comparing aaa to aaa we're going to see
that they are equal and we're going to
get a 0 printed out here you're going to
see that this is exactly the case when
we get to play with us in visual studio
code in a minute
we have a facility that we can use to
search in a string and search for a
character the facility for that is sdr
chr and it is going to find the first
occurrence of a character in a string
and the documentation for this is right
here
and please note that this example is
actually copied
straight from the documentation
okay so we have a message here
it is a character array and it is
pointed to by a const car pointer called
hdr and we have a target character that
we are looking for
and the result is going to be stored in
the result character array here and we
have a variable called iterations that
is going to keep track of how many
iterations we did to find our target
here the way this guy works it is going
to return a pointer to what you find
if it is found for example in here if we
find this first t this function here or
this facility is going to return a
pointer to this first t here
if it doesn't find what we want it is
going to return a null pointer that's
how it works and you can see that in the
documentation here we are going to take
advantage of how it works in this while
loop here and the way you use this
facility you give it the strength you
want to search in and you give it the
character that you are looking for so if
we look at how it works in the while
loop here we are going to call the
function
and we are going to store the result in
our character pointer here and if we go
inside we're going to hit the first
character here at the first iteration so
we're going to find this t here and when
we find it the result of this is going
to be stored back in result here
i hope this makes sense so we're going
to find it we're going to print it and
we're going to increment result to make
it point to the next character this is
pointer arithmetic in action here
and after we do that we're going to
increment the iterations so we should
have one iteration by now and we're
going to jump into the loop again so the
string we search in is going to be
starting from r here
so we're going to try and find
an uppercase tn and it is going to find
this uppercase t here so it is going to
point to it and the pointer to this t
is going to be stored in this result
here okay and we're going to jump into
our body here we're going to say that we
found this t we're going to print it out
and we're going to increment results if
we increment reserved now research is
going to be pointing to the h here
okay and we're going to
say how many iterations we did to find
our thing we will have printed out the t
that we have found and we're going to
jump to the next iteration which is
going to be searching for t
in the reminder of the string here it's
not going to find it of course it's
going to return no pointer and the test
here is going to fail and we're going to
fall down here and say how many
iterations we found i realize this
example can be really confusing i am
going to try and explain it again when
we hit visual studio code for now note
that this facility can help you find
characters in a string that's the
message here there is also another
function that helps you find the last
occurrence of a character in a string
for example here we have a character
input
it is a path to a file on some limit
system or mac system
and we have an output character pointer
which is going to store the pointer to
the character that we found okay if we
find the character we're going to store
in the pointer to that character if we
don't find it we're going to return no
pointer i think that's how this thing
works
so what we really want here
is to hunt for the file name in this
path here and this is really interesting
so we're going to search for the
backslash the last one and this string
here and it is going to find this guy
here because that's the last occurrence
of the backslash
in our input string here once we find it
we're going to get a pointer to this guy
stored in the output character pointer
here and we're going to print it out
what we're going to do we're going to
use pointer arithmetic to move this
pointer to the next guy because that's
what we really want we want to print
starting from the edge here and that's
what we're going to get when we print
this out
now that we have looked at all these
examples i think it is time we headed to
visual studio code and actually played
with them okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is c
string manipulation that's what we're
going to work on we're going to copy our
template files and we're going to put
that in place
and we're going to open this in visual
studio code pretty quick let's include c
string because that's what we're going
to be using many of the things we're
going to be playing with in this lecture
are documented in this piece of
documentation here so you can come here
and get more details than we could even
cover in a course like this let's bring
this up a little bit and we're going to
go in our main function and put in the
first piece of code we can play with the
str land facility is going to find the
length of the strength and it's going to
work regardless of whether you are using
a row array like this or even if you are
using the character pointer to point to
your array and this is pretty cool so
here we have strlen message one we're
going to print that out we're going to
print how many characters we have in
this guy here
we're going to also use the size of
operator to try and compare these things
but please know that the null character
is going to be included if you use
sizeof here on a row array
this is very important to know
but one interesting thing about hdr lan
is that it is also going to work if you
are storing your array
and something that is pointed to by
pointer so even decayed pointers
are going to be usable here and this is
pretty cool so we can also try and print
the size of message 2 which is pointed
to by a row pointer and we're going to
see what we get but we know that we're
going to get the size of a pointer
because that's what it really is message
two here is just a pointer okay let's
close this on the left
and we are going to bring up our
terminal
and i try and build this with gcc we're
going to do that so we're going to use
gcc to build this
the world is going to go through
and we're going to clear and run rooster
again
and this is going to give us what we
want sqr lan message 1 is 16
size of message 1 is 17 because sizeof
is also going to count
the null character htrlen message2 you
see that it works even if
we have a decayed array
that is pointed to by a pointer and this
is really useful if you happen to need
the size of an array like this you can
use hdr then and you're going to get the
size of data in there but know that the
null terminating character is not
counted if you use hdr ln here and size
of message 2 is going to be 8 because
that's the size of a pointer on our
system here so know that this guy is
just a pointer
okay that's the message here
we are going to comment this out the
next thing we're going to look at is
strcmp which can be used to compare
strengths
so it works exactly like we say it's
going to return something negative if
the first string happens to come in
front of the second string in
lexicographical
order
for example here we have a few variables
we have alabama and blabama there are
strengths pointed to by
pointers
so they are c strings
and we have a couple of other strings
stored in row arrays like this and by
doing this i want to prove that this
facility is going to work regardless of
how your array or your c string is
stored so we're going to use that here
for our
c string pointer 2 by pointers
we're going to try and compare whatever
is in a string data one
with string data two string data one has
alabama string data two has blah blah so
if we compare these guys we expect to
get a negative value out of this thing
here
strcmp
because alabama comes in front of
blabama in our alphabet so a is in front
of b so we're going to get a negative
value out of this and we expect to get
the same thing in the second example
here which is going to be using what we
store in our row array
so make sure you understand this and
we're going to try and build this to see
that it passes through our gcc compiler
the buzz is good
so we're going to clear
and run rooster and you're going to see
that we get a negative one
i want you to play with this thanks and
try and change for example the 8 with c
and see what you get
okay we're going to try and build but
before we do try to expect to see what
you get c comes after blah blah
so
if we look at this description here we
should get a positive value because
the first guy comes after
the second guy in lexicographical order
so we should get a positive value
for the first thing that we print here
okay let's weld and see if that's the
case we're going to build successfully
we're going to clear and run rooster and
you see that the first guy prints a one
because
cla gamma comes before blah blah
and the second one is going to
still be a negative one because we still
have
whatever we had before in there okay
this is how you work with this thanks
let's turn this back to alabama
so that we are not confused
and we're going to keep
working on this and the next piece of
code we are going to try and modify
whatever is stored in string data 1 and
string data 2 and print the comparisons
out
for example we have alabama and album
and by the way we are able to modify
that
because it is a pointer to a strength
and notice that this is not the
conspirator so we can really change
where this guy is pointing and that's
what we are doing here but we can't do
that with string data 3 and string data
4 because these are arrays and remember
you can't change where an array points
so this is going to compile nice but if
we try and do the same thing with string
data 3 and string data four
let's do that you're going to get a
compiler error
so we're going to put this guy here and
say three
and four
and we should see visual studio code
complaining here because this is not
allowed you're not allowed to make an
array
point to another location and this is
just another
character array or cost character array
in memory that we want this pointers to
point to or this array to point to and
this is not possible so we're going to
get a compiler error if we do this this
is something i wanted you to know that's
why i set up this example here so if we
run this we're going to see the first
line of output here
or i think i should comment that out
or let's not comment it out now if we
run this program we're going to get the
output for obama and alabama printed out
and alabama comes after alabama so we
expect to get a negative one because the
first guy here comes in front of the
second guy so we're going to get a
negative one
out of
the
thing we are doing here let's try in
world with gcc
the builder is going to be good so we're
going to clear and run rooster and we're
going to see that we have a negative one
here alabama comes in front of a lab
so this is cool so we can try and put in
many other examples for you to play with
i am going to do that because i don't
want to type all this thanks and we're
going to print the results out for
example we put in india and france we
put in kigali and kigali and we're going
to get things printed out here so let's
build this so that we don't waste time
we're going to clear and we're going to
run rooster
and we're going to see that we get these
things here alakama comes after alabama
so we get a one
india comes after france we get a one
shigari comes together with kigali and
we get a zero you can try and put in
whatever you want these are just a few
examples for you to play with and by now
i hope you really understand how this
function works or this facility works so
we're going to comment it out whatever
we did here
so we're going to comment all this out
so that we don't have noise output in
whatever we want to do next and what we
want to look at next is this function
here which is going to compare
strings in the same ways but we're going
to tell it to compare however many
characters in the string and you see
that my string here has been commented
up i can quickly take it and bring it
down here let's do that i can't find
that
let's find that and copy it down
and we're going to find them here so i'm
going to find this
and bring that down here so that i can
compare these things so let's come down
here and print and put in our
declarations for this strengths and you
see that visual studio code is happy now
so what we're going to do is compare a
set of characters in these strings here
okay so we're going to compare any
characters in our strengths so we're
going to compare allah to blah here and
allah is going to come in front of black
so we're going to have a negative one
printed out here but if we change the
strengths to aaa and aaa here and
compare the first three characters we're
going to get a zero printed out because
the first three characters are equal and
again the special thing about this
function is that it allows you to
specify
a number of characters you want compared
in these two strings so you can say i
want to compare three strands you can
say i want to compare four strings or
five
just make sure that you don't go over
the size of the string and if you do
that it's not going to make sense what
you are trying to do here if we go down
here we're going to change n to 5 and
we're going to be comparing all these
things in here and we're going to get
that
the first one comes in front of the
second one because i comes in front of n
in our alphabet if we change the data to
o here and n
o is going to come after n and we're
going to get a positive number printed
out here we're going to try and run this
so let's run the task to build with jcc
the bullet is going to be good and we're
going to clear and run rooster
and we're going to see that alabama
comes in front of blabama because we are
comparing the first three characters
if we have aaa in here and we compare
the three characters you're going to see
that they are equal we get a zero
if we change i
and n here we're going to get a negative
one because i comes in front of n
if we use o here and n we're going to
get a one because o comes after n this
is really simple to understand now that
we know how to use the first version of
string compare this version is just
going to allow us to specify how many
characters in the string we want
compared so we're going to comment this
out and we are going to go down and do
another example that allows us to search
for a character in a string
and the method we use to do that is std
str
chr
so this guy is going to find whatever
target you want to find and if it finds
that it's going to return you a pointer
to dot's target if it doesn't find it
it's going to return you no pointer so
we set up an array here and we store
that in a location that is pointed to by
the pointer to character here and we say
whatever target we are looking for in
this case we want to find this t here
we are going to set up another character
array that is going to store our results
the result is really going to be a
pointer which is going to be pointing to
something valid if we find the target
and it's going to be no equator if we
didn't find the target and we set up
another variable which is going to store
how many iterations we did we should
really make this an unsigned integer or
size t so let's make that here and we're
going to loop here so the first time
we'll open here we're going to call this
guy we're going to say i want to find a
t
and result here and the result is going
to be pointing to this line here because
we did the assignment here so it's going
to go and try to find the t it's going
to find the guy here at the first index
and the test here is going to succeed
when it succeeds it's not going to be
equal to no pointer it's going to be
pointing to a valid pointer
and it's going to succeed and return the
pointer to be stored in resort after
this guide returns the pointer is going
to be stored in the result here and
that's going to be a pointer to this
team and we're going to jump in the body
here i really want you to understand how
this thing is going to work
once we get to the body we're going to
say uh-huh we found our target that's
going to be our t print it out and it's
going to start at this location
okay and we're going to print starting
from the t here because that's what our
result here is pointing to after we do
that we're going to increment the result
to make it point to the next character
if we do that with pointer arithmetic
now we're going to be pointing to the r
in here
i hope this makes sense and we're going
to increment our iterations so we're
going to say we have done one iteration
and we're going to try and run this
again and by the time we get in here
we're going to have this string here in
which we are searching for a t
and it is going to be found starting at
this second t here there here
and it's going to find it
it's going to store the pointer to it to
resort here or i should say the search
is going to be successful so we're going
to find the pointer to this t
and return it from this function here
and the pointer is going to be stored in
our result
pointer here we're going to jump in the
body and we're going to print we found
the target starting at this t we're
going to print that out and stdc out is
going to print until it meets an old
character so we're going to print this
thing through the end and we're going to
put a slash n which is going to move us
to the next line after we do that we're
going to increment result
and uh result now is going to point to
the h here
and we're going to increment iterations
now we're going to have done two
iterations by now and we're going to run
the loop again this time the loop is
going to fail because starting from here
we don't have a t
and that this function is going to
return no pointer and this test here is
going to fail okay we are going to
return no pointer no pointer is not
going to be different from no pointer so
this is going to fail and we're going to
fall down here and say how many
iterations we're going to find so in
total we're going to do two iterations
and we are going to find two t's and
we're going to print whatever we find
here make sure you really understand
this
and i put in this example on purpose
because it is a little complicated but
it is going to really bring your game up
in how you use these functions from the
c plus plus standard library and you
really need to know this if you have any
problem with this
be sure to ask me i will do the best i
can to help you out so we're going to
build this and run this we're going to
build with gcc as always and we are
going to clear and run rooster and
you're going to see that we are looking
for t
we are going to say we found t starting
at the t here so we're going to say try
okay we're going to print all the
message out and the second iteration is
going to find t
starting at this location here and we're
going to do two iterations in total
we're going to comment this out and
again if you don't understand this
please go through it again and if you
still don't understand be sure to ask me
i am going to do the best i can to help
you out and some of you might be asking
why did we go through the trouble to
store this guy in a result
why don't we use htr
in the first place in here
and the explanation i can come up with
is that you don't really want to modify
this guy here because somebody is going
to look at this thing and say
this is the message i have in sdr here
but if you try and modify this in the
loop it's going to be messed up because
you're going to be incrementing it and
doing all kinds of crazy things on it so
you don't really want to modify this so
a better way to even do this is to mark
this as a const pointer and we know how
to do that so we can say cost here and
if you even try to increment htr
somewhere you're going to get a compiler
error
so let's make sure we see that for
example we try and do plus plus sdr
we're going to get a compiler error
because this is a const pointer by now
and this is much safer
okay
we're going to comment this out and show
you something that might throw off many
of you guys so we're going to comment
this out and i am going to bring that in
okay let's go down here
and we are going to do basically the
same thing
but we will try
and use str in the first place here
okay this is how we're going to do this
we're going to have our string we're
going to have our target we're going to
have our result here which is equal to
null pointer and we have our iterations
which is an integer let's make this a
size t and what we're going to do in
here we're going to use htr to search
okay and we're going to basically do the
same checks we're going to jump in here
and say we found the target starting at
result and we're going to increment hdr
here because it is not a constrainer now
try to go through this thing here and
see how many times you're going to loop
okay go through it and when you are done
we're going to try and run this we're
going to build with gcc the build is
going to be good we are going to clear
and run rooster and you see that this
guy is going to look 25 times
and this is crazy why is this happening
why is this happening
what we really are doing here we are not
assigning the result in this trend that
we are searching at
okay let's try and go through this a
couple of times so the first time we're
going to do our search okay so we're
going to search in sdr
and if we find our target we're going to
return the pointer to the target
if we don't find it we're going to
return a null pointer the first time
we're going to find this t here okay and
we're going to return a pointer to it
and store that in result
okay so after we do this we're going to
fall in our body here
and we're going to say we found t
starting at this location here that's
going to work and we're going to
implement str okay notice that we're not
incrementing result here
if we increment sdr it's going to point
to the next character which is r here
okay
and we're going to increment our
iterations and we're going to start in
loop again
we're going to search in here
and we're going to be searching from
this location here
and we're going to find the t starting
at this location we are going to find
this t here and we're going to
return that and store that in reserved
but the problem is that what we are
incrementing here but the problem here
is that we are incrementing one by one
we are not jumping to this t here and we
had a way to jump to this t
by assigning the result into the same
variable that we are searching in okay
so this is going to loop 25 times and it
is not really good and some of you might
try to set up something like this and it
is really not going to be good try to go
through this and you're going to see the
reason why it is looping 25 times okay i
wanted you to see this don't do
something like this and we are going to
comment this out the next thing we're
going to see is how we can find the last
occurrence of the character and this is
a really cool example i like it it is
going to do something very practical we
are going to take a path which is going
to be an array basically stored in this
input array and we're going to strip off
all the things we don't need and we're
going to hunt down for the file name
from a full path and this can be useful
in whatever application you are doing so
we are going to hunt for the last
occurrence of a backslash character
using the str or
chr facility in the ziploc squad
standard library and you can find the
documentation on this guy here i'm not
going to go there you should really
practice to go there and read what these
things do that's why i am living in the
lens to the documentation you should go
there and read and if you have a problem
you can ask me i will do the best i can
to help you out
so this line here is going to hunt for
the last
backslash it's going to find this guy
here and we're going to store a pointer
to that in our output character pointer
here after we do that we're going to say
if we found something useful if this is
not no pointer we're going to print that
out but we don't want to print starting
from the backslash we are going to use
pointer arithmetic and move to the next
character which is going to be this h
here so if we print this out we're going
to have hello cpp printed out because
sddc out is going to print until it
meets
the last now character and that's going
to be after the last p here because this
is a c string let's roll here okay we're
going to build this the build is going
to be good we're going to clear
and run rooster and you're going to see
that we have hello cpp
printed out here okay this is really all
we set out to do in this lecture i
apologize that it turned out to be
lengthy these things can take long to
explain and i really wanted you guys to
have as many explanations as i could
come up with
we are going to stop here in this
lecture the next one we're going to see
how we can copy and concatenate
c strings using the facilities from c
string here go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to look at
a few more facilities from the c string
library and those are going to allow us
to concatenate and copy strings over the
documentation for what we're going to be
talking about can be found here if you
go there you're going to fall on this
link here and you're going to
find that c string was originally in the
c standard library as string dot h but
in c plus plus we can use it like this
we have a couple of functions we can
copy stuff we can concatenate we can get
the string length we have seen this but
now we're going to look at things that
allow us to copy and concatenate stuff
because
that's something you may want to do a
lot the first example we're going to
look at is
stdstr cat which is going to allow you
to join strengths
again you can browse to the
documentation here and see more about
this facility here and you're going to
see all about it for now we're just
going to play with it we're going to set
up two arrays one is going to be called
dest
it's going to contain hello the other is
going to be source here and it's going
to contain worlds notice that these are
row static arrays that are stored on the
snap
and uh that's how we set them up here
okay so we can concatenate strengths
using the syntax like this we're going
to say hdd hdr cache we're going to say
the destination string and we're going
to say the source string we want to copy
from okay so after we do this the
destination is going to contain
these two strings joined together and
before you do this you have to be sure
that your destination strength is big
enough and this is a problem because you
have to really keep track of your
destination strength and it is easy to
put in many more characters that can
really fit in the destinations rank
that's the reason many of these
functions here are considered unsafe by
many compilers i don't think you can
compile this on visual studio it's going
to stop you from doing this because of
this
way
you have to keep track of things
yourself but i am just showing you so
that you know how to avoid these
problems if you happen to be on a
compiler that doesn't protect you from
this so we're going to append goodbye
world to whatever is in dust and down
here if we print this we're going to
have hello world goodbye world printed
out we are going to play with this in a
visual studio code in a minute don't
worry if any of this doesn't make sense
yet here is another example of how we
can join strengths through strcat
we have two strengths and we set them up
with a simple characters like this you
can do this and put in your own now
terminating character this is a legal c
plus plus could and notice that this
array is a dynamic array it's going to
leave on the hip because of this new
operator here we also have a source
array which is also going to leave on
the hip it is 30 characters long so it
is really long and we're going to try
and concatenate stance here but before
we do that we're going to check their
length we're going to print them out and
we are going to concatenate the syntax
is the same you are going to say hdr cat
you're going to specify your destination
and your source you're going to be
copying stuff from and you are going to
store the result in destination here
what this is going to do it's going to
grab whatever is in source and copy it
so it's going to copy the entire thing
here from source and it's going to
append that to whatever we have in
destination starting from the last null
character here so it's going to
overwrite from this null character and
it's going to basically copy everything
and the destination here and if we print
whatever we have in destination here
we're going to have firelord
the phoenix kind of printed out and
you're going to see that this is going
to be the case when we hit visual studio
code in a minute you can also use a
version of the sdr cat version that is
going to allow you to specify
how many characters you want to
concatenate from the source string in
this case we have destination which is
hello and we have source which is there
is a bird
on my window
and down here you see that we do hdr and
cat we save the destination we save the
source and we say how many characters we
want copied from the source here and we
say six characters so we are going to
count from the source we're going to say
one two three four five six we're going
to grab this their string with this
space here and we're going to append
that to the source and that's what we're
going to get in here we're going to say
hello space and there and that's what
we're going to have printed out here if
we print dust we can also copy stuff and
the str cpy function here is going to do
that and here we have an example that is
going to try and drive this home for you
we have a source strength which is c
plus plus is a multi-purpose programming
language okay guest three here is going
to be the same length as the source we
made sure of that in here because we're
going to grab the length of the source
strength please remember that sdrlam is
not going to count
the null character that's why we are
adding a one here to account for the
noun terminating character here okay
after that we're going to jump down here
and say htr cpy dest 3 and source 3 we
are basically going to be copying from
source and pasting
in destination here that's what we are
doing if we print destination we're
going to see that now it's going to
contain whatever we had in source and
this is how you can use these methods
here we also have a version
with which we can specify how many
characters we want copied from the
source here we have a source string
which is hello we have a destination
string which is zest 4 and we are going
to copy stuff we're going to copy from
the source we're going to paste in the
destination and we are just going to
copy five characters what this is going
to do is copy everything from the source
and paste in our destination and it is
going to override whatever we have in
the starting indexes in destination here
so we're going to have a b c d e here
replaced by hello and if we print this
here we're going to have hello f printed
out this is how these things work and if
you wonder how i know how these things
work i just come and read the
documentation here for example htr and
cpy here if we click on it we are going
to get the documentation this is going
to say copies at most count characters
of the byte string
source including the null terminating
character to the character array pointed
to by desk that's what it does we have
the destination we have the source and
we have how many characters we want
copied and they say a few things you
need to be careful about this guy here
one thing that you usually care about is
the return value you see that the return
value is going to be the destination
strength so if you want this pointer you
can use it and you can go down and look
at a few examples here and play with
them to really drive the point home okay
now that you have an idea about how
these guys work we are going to head
over to visual studio code and play with
them
right away okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is c
string concatenation and copy that's
what we are doing here we're going to
copy our template files and uh jump to
our current project and put them in
place we're going to open this in visual
studio code pretty quick we are going to
include c string because that's what
we're going to be using here we are
going to bring this up a little bit and
we are going to put in our first example
here we have two strengths
destination and source and you see that
we tried and made sure that they are
large enough to contain however many
characters we want to put in
and they are row arrays stored on the
stack because they are set up like this
and again you can check out the
documentation here if you want to know
how this function works and we are going
to call strcat here to concatenate the
source to our destination here so if we
do this we're going to have world here
concatenated to what we have in hello
here and we're going to have hello world
in place for example if we try and print
this out i'm going to try and do that
after we do the first concatenation here
let's do that that's going to be better
to show you how these things work okay
after the first function here runs we're
going to have source concatenated to
destination here so what we're going to
have is hello world stored in
destination here the second
concatenation here is going to append
goodbye world to whatever we have in
destination here so what we're going to
have printed down is if we print that of
course is hello world and goodbye world
okay we're going to have this written
down let's try and run this and actually
make sure that that's the case and then
we're going to see how this function can
be unsafe for some compilers we're going
to build this with gcc you see that it's
going to go through
and if we run this we're going to have
hello world hello world goodbye world
printed out this is what we expect and
again
this function here sdr cat is going to
have whatever you have in source and it
is going to append that to whatever you
have in destination and for this to work
you have to be sure that the destination
is modifiable for example if it was an
array of cost core let's do that and
show you the compiler error we should
get a compiler error because now
destination is not modifiable it is an
array of cost characters and we can't
modify it so be sure
the destination array is modifiable and
in this case it is okay please note that
some of these functions can be treated
as unsafe by some compilers but i tried
this out on both on gcc and the compiler
from microsoft and they work pretty well
so you can try them out here to prove
that let's go and try and build with the
compiler from microsoft we have it
set up here
so we're going to run the task to build
with msvc here
and you're going to see that the world
is going to be good the world finished
successfully and if we go and we're
going to clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
it is going to do exactly the same thing
but some compilers might give you
warnings or errors if you try to do
something like this and the reason is
you really have to be careful using
these functions because if for example
destination array is not large enough
you may do some crazy things running
over the balance of your array and it
can be really bad for example if we try
and make destination array here for
example a size of three it is possible
to do that and you see that we get a
warning from visual studio code and if
we try and build this with gcc let's try
and remove the garbage we have from
visual studio first now that this is
clean we can uh try and build with gcc
let's do that our compiler we're going
to choose gcc and you're going to see
that it's going to give you an error
it's going to actually protect us from
doing something like this but in some
cases some compilers are not going to
stop you from doing this but any
compiler that really respects itself
it's going to have these safety checks
in and it's going to protect you from
doing something crazy like this okay
this is how you can do concatenation
using hdr cat like we did here let's try
and weld and see that now we are
building fine because i don't like these
red lines here the world is good and we
are all fine now i am going to comment
this out
and we're going to see another example
of how we can concatenate stuff we are
going to go down here let's bring this
down and hide this
and we are going to put in our simple
example exactly the same thing we saw in
the slides we have two
character arrays they are dynamic arrays
but we initialize them with characters
like this and we make sure to put in our
null
terminator we have our source strength
which is going to say the
femix king and it's going to have a
terminator here
and what we're going to do we're going
to take soros and concatenate that to
our destination so what is really going
to happen we are going to overwrite the
null terminator here and we're going to
start pasting in things from source here
so after the concatenation is done what
we are doing here we are concatenating
source one to test one
we are going to have fire lord the
phoenix kang stored in our destination
string here
and notice that we made sure that
large enough to contain our characters
here and if we print it out we're going
to have the thing printed out we can try
and weld with gcc that's going to go
through let's bring this up the bulb is
good
if you go down here the build is good
we're going to clear and run rooster
okay this is the output here you see
that the destination is eight characters
long if we count one two three four five
six seven eight remember sdrl lan
doesn't count the null character so this
is what we expect eight characters the
source is going to be 17 characters if
you count all this that's what you're
going to get
and if we concatenate them now this
donation is going to be
25 characters long
in the eyes of hdr land and you see that
we print the destination and it is
exactly what we expect fire lord the
phoenix gang okay we're going to comment
this out i just wanted you to see an
example of this and the one thing i
really want to stress in this example
is that strcat is going to start
overriding whatever is in dust starting
at the last null character okay so this
guy is going to be overridden by the
comma here and we're going to start and
putting stuff and that's what we're
going to see here let's comment this out
because we want to move on and show you
a few other examples okay the next thing
we're going to look at is a new version
of str cat that allows you to specify
how many characters you want
concatenated
from source for example here we have two
strengths destination and source and
here we are basically saying i want to
concatenate six characters from source
and put them at the end of the
destination here and what it's going to
do it's going to grab one two three four
five six it's going to grab this entire
thing and it's going to append that to
hello and we're going to have hello
there stored in the destination and the
return value is going to be a pointer to
destination 2. and how do i know the
return value well i know that from the
documentation if you go in your favorite
search engine and do
stdstr and cat and you're going to see a
link here if you click on it from cpp
reference it's going to give you
everything you need to know about this
function here it's going to append
source to destination and and count
characters are going to be copied so the
third parameter here is going to be how
many characters you want copied and
pasted into our destination
and the return value is going to be dest
okay if we try this out we're going to
see hello there printed out we're going
to print it out directly and we're going
to print that out
using the destination pointer that is
going to be returned from this guy here
so if we try and build this we're going
to build with gcc the bullet is going to
be good we're going to clear and run
rooster and you're going to see that we
have hello there twice here and this is
exactly what we expect
we are going to comment this out and we
are going to go down and look at sdr cpi
i should say sdr cpy which is going to
copy stuff from the source and paste
those in the destination and one thing
you should know is that the copy is
going to happen starting from the start
of the destination array here we have
two arrays one is called source three
the other is called destination three
destination 3 is set up on the heap
using the new operator so it is a
dynamic array and you see that we make
sure that it is the same size as the
source
we are using sdr lan to figure out how
many characters we have in here
and remember that sdr land doesn't
account for the null character so we are
adding one to account for the null
character that's what we are doing here
and after that we are going to do std
str cpy and what that is going to do is
copy stuff from source to destination
character by character so we are
basically going to have this guy pasted
into destination here and if we print
things out we're going to see that
destination contains the same thing as
source here if we built this with gcc
let's do that the build is going to be
good we can clear
and run rooster and you're going to see
that the destination has exactly the
same thing we had in the source and if
you need to copy stuff from arrays sdr
cpui is going to be very helpful
we are going to comment this out because
we still have a few things we want to
see
so let's comment this out we are going
to go down and see that we can also use
a another version that allows us to
specify how many characters we want
copied from the source okay in this
example here we are using std str and
cpy and this n here means that we can
specify the count of characters we do
whatever
the current function is doing here okay
so we are specifying i want five
characters copied from source and i want
those pasted into destination here
that's what we are saying here and the
source is going to contain hello
destination is going to contain the
world and the copy is going to happen
starting at the first index here so
we're going to have hello override
whatever we have in a b c d e because
that's five characters here and the dust
is going to contain hello f if we print
it out let's build this and see if
that's what we're going to get we're
going to build with gcc the build is
going to go through
we are going to clear and run rooster
and you see that that's exactly what we
have here
okay this is how these methods work
there are many more functions you can
use
from the c string library and again if
you want to see
a list of them all you can go through
your
favorite search engine and search for c
string
and we can specify cpp reference here
let's try and do that okay we can find a
link to that we can click on that and
it's going to open up and show us many
more functions we can use and if you
need to know about a special function
you can click on it and see what it does
and if you go down you're going to find
even an example of how you can use it
for now we are going to stop here in
this lecture and this is actually going
to be the last lecture we see on c
strings the next one we're going to
start and look at std strength which is
a compound type that makes working with
strengths
very easy in c plus plus
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
start and learn about hdd strength which
is a type that is going to make it super
easy to work with string data we have
seen many ways we can work with
character arrays by now we can use row
rays we can point to them with pointers
we can even allocate arrays on the hip
but all these character arrays had a few
problems that are really a pain in the
neck to deal with on a daily basis
one of those problems was that you had
to keep the size in check you have to
know how many
elements you have in the character array
and that was defining the bounds that
you can work in if you go over bounds we
have seen that that can cause crashes of
your program and you don't want that
another problem was that we had 3d to
remember to keep track of the null
character if we don't have it in place
we're going to have problems when our
string is printed out and it's really
annoying to always have to think about
these little details when all you really
want is to store a strand so c plus plus
offers a high level type that we can use
and it is going to hide all these little
details underground and all we have to
do is put in our string and use it and
we can be on our merry way and do
whatever we want to do with string data
in our c plus plus application so that's
what we're going to do we're going to
have a type that is going to wrap on top
of the ugly array computations we have
been doing on character arrays we're
going to call that std string and we're
going to be able to do many of the
things we were doing with c strings but
in a much better way we can concatenate
we can search we can copy we can do all
kinds of crazy things really but it's
going to be in a way that you don't have
to worry about these little details
about array bounds the null character
you're going to just use it for what you
want which is storing character or text
data okay so that's what we're going to
be doing in the next few lectures we're
going to be learning about std string
and how you can use it in your c plus
plus applications and it's going to make
your life a whole lot easier we are
going to stop here in this lecture the
next one we're going to see how you can
declare initialize and use std strength
in your c plus plus application go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there and
this lecture we're going to see how you
can declare and use hdd strength in your
c plus plus applications
std strength is a type that is going to
wrap on top of arrays and give us a
really nice interface
that we can use to
store string data without having to deal
with the ugly little details like
keeping track of array bound remembering
to keep in check the null character and
things like that to use std strength you
will need to include the string library
and after you do this you can declare
and use your strings just like this here
we have a series of examples just to get
you started on this you declare your
strengths just like you declare any
other time you specify the type on the
left the type is going to be std
strength by the way you'll have to
remember to use std column column like
this and we will have a chance to
explain why in a few chapters ahead but
for now we're just going to think of std
strength as a type so we declare a
string type we call it full name and we
can leave it like this uninitialized and
it is going to be an empty strand we can
also put in our string and initialize
that with a string literal and it is
going to work another way of doing this
is initializing a string with another
string which we are doing down here you
can also set up another string and
initialize it with part of another
string literal so for example message
here is going to be hello and it's only
going to grab five characters from this
string literal this is something you
might want to do
if it makes sense for whatever
application you are doing here we can
also initialize our strength with
multiple copies of one character and
this is the syntax to do it you say
the name of your variable you say
however many times you want the
character repeated and you say which
character it is just like this we can
also initialize a string with part of
another existing string so for example
here we have saying hello and it is
initialized with part of what we have in
greeting here so we're going to start at
index 6 which is going to be
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 on the w here and we're
going to grab five characters so one two
three four five and that's what we're
going to use to initialize this saying
hello here and if we print it out we're
going to see that this is going to be
exactly the case so hopefully you can
see that it is easier you don't have to
use pointers you don't have to use
arrays and the best part is std strength
can grow automatically if you happen to
store in more characters than you
initialized it with in the first place
and that's pretty cool so now we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and play with us so that you can see for
yourself okay here we are in our working
folder the current project is declaring
and using std strength which is what we
are doing here we're going to grab our
template files pretty quick and we're
going to go and store in the files and
we're going to open the folder and we're
going to include the strength library
let's do that okay this is how we do it
and now that we have it included in our
project we can start declaring and using
std string
types in our c plus plus program we are
going to go down and put in the code to
play with this a little bit so you can
declare an empty string like this and
it's not going to have anything inside
you can declare a string and put in a
string literal like we are doing here
and std string knows how to handle this
so it's going to store it inside using a
character array but we don't have to
really worry about that character array
is going to work we're just going to use
std string here we can set up a string
using another string in our initializer
like this we can also use
part of a literal to initialize the
string so for example
this string literal here we're going to
grab part of it and we're going to grab
five characters and use those to
initialize our message std string here
and this is pretty cool we can also use
multiple characters to initialize a
string like this we say however many
copies we want of this character in this
string here and it is going to be
exactly what we want so it's going to be
four e's
in this weird message string
and we can initialize the string with
part of another string and this is
really cool and it may come in handy in
many applications so for example here
saying hello is going to contain
world here and we are saying that this
is what we want by saying we want to
start at index six in this string here
so if we go zero one two three four five
six this is going to be our character at
index six and from this index we're
going to grab five characters so we're
going to count one two three four five
and that's going to be what's stored in
this string here and if you don't
believe me we can print all these things
out and they are going to be exactly
what we expect and by this you can even
see that we can print std strengths
using sddc out
very conveniently like this and this is
very cool okay so we can try and weld
this with gcc the build is going to go
through so we're going to bring up a
terminal so that we can run this and
we're going to clear and let's see what
we see when we
run rooster here so we're going to print
the full name the full name is empty
okay so we're not going to see anything
because it is empty we're going to see
planet planet is this thing we have in
here planet where the sky is blue so
this is what we expect we can say
preferred planet and put in the text for
the planet here so we're going to get
the same thing here
and if we have a message and say hello
there and grab the
first characters in this string literal
message is going to say hello which is
what we are saying here let's go down
and look at where the message is going
to be for ease which is what we have
here and we can initialize saying hello
with part of what we have in greeting
and we have targeted this word string
here and it is what we see here and this
is pretty cool the good thing about hdd
string however is that you can
store in more characters than we
initialize this guy with so for example
here we have this message here but we
can say
planet let's go down here and say it
we're going to change std string at run
time so we're going to say planet and
we're going to assign something to it
we're going to put in whatever was in
there first and we're going to paste
that in multiple times let's do three
times i think that's going to be enough
or we can even bring this back so that
we see the entire thing here doesn't
really matter all we want is for this
thing to be larger than it was initially
declared
in a planet here so we're going to
remove these quotes because they are
making things ugly for us and now it's
going to be a valid strength let's wait
for visual studio code to realize that
and it's going to remove these squiggly
lines now we are good std string is
automatically going to take care of the
logic
to make this string grow we don't have
to worry about that and if we print
planet now we're going to see the same
details and taken care of okay this is
really cool and it makes it super easy
to work with
text and string data like you see here
so let's build again so that our changes
are
reflected in our output we're going to
clear and run rooster and we're going to
see that planet is now really large okay
we can change
this thing the size of this thing at
runtime and this is something we
couldn't do with arrays so for example
if we go down here and use a row array
to do something like this this code is
going to run but try to think about what
is really happening here we have an
array which contains this text here
and it is pointed to by this cost card
pointer that we have if we try and do an
assignment like this this is really
going to be to make it point to another
character array in memory and this piece
of memory here is basically going to be
wasted because we think we have our
planet strength in here
this is not the case with std strength
because std strength when we do
something like this the initial memory
that was allocated to store
planet here is going to be returned to
the operand system and a new memory is
going to be allocated to contain this
new thing so the waste we're doing here
by just leaving this in memory and not
using it is not being done here so if we
try to print we're going to get the same
output but inside and how our memory is
managed hdd string is better in that the
memory that was used to initialize this
guy is not wasted out
here with array what we really are doing
is just make this planet pointer point
to another string and leaving this to be
wasted in memory this is what we are
doing here and we can avoid that with
std strength
in this lecture we're going to learn
about the one definition rule and this
is a rule that says definitions can't
show up more than once in your entire c
plus plus program or in some cases a
definition can show up more than once in
a translation unit we are going to look
at the one definition rule in the
context of freestanding variables
functions classes member functions and
static members in our classes in most
cases a definition can't really show up
more than once in your entire c-plus
plus program but we have exceptions to
this rule and the exception is for
classes a definition for a class can
show up in multiple translation unit and
the reason is
we need to create objects of those
classes so each translation unit really
needs to see the definition for the
class and we are going to try and make
this super clear with examples once we
hit visual studio code okay so it is
time to head over to visual studio code
and shed some more light on the one
definition rule here we are in our
working folder the current project is
one definition rule we're going to grab
our template files like we always do
we're going to put them in place and
we're going to open this little guy in
visual studio code let's do that i'm
going to drag and drop and we're going
to have our main cpp file here we're
going to clean it up that's what we
always do
and now we want to explore the one
definition rule in the context of
variables so we have a freestanding
variable here
and that's going to be the same variable
we had in the last lecture we're going
to initialize this and this is really
good we can use it we can go in main and
use it however we want we can print the
way
and if we won't run this program it is
going to work but the one definition
rule says we can't have more than one
definition for anything and for this
variable here we have seen that this is
both a declaration
and a definition so we can't have more
than one definition for the weight name
here for example if we try and grab it
and copy and paste it here so we're
going to try and build this program
we're going to use gcc
we're going to see that we have a
problem and the problem is going to say
redefinition
of double weight and it is not going to
help even if you take this and put that
in another file so let's create another
file to really show you that we're going
to call it some other file that cpp and
we're going to grab our redefinition
and move that there
and you're going to see that if we try
and build this program
we're going to get the same problem
we're going to have redefinition so
we're going to see
what is the problem here the compiler
error is a little bit different but it
is going to say multiple definitions of
weight
and it's going to say one is defined in
the main cpp file so this is a linker
error this was caught by the laker
because the redefinition is showing up
in multiple files so the linker was
linking this program and it needed to
see a definition for weight and it had
seen one definition in the main cpp file
and it has seen another definition and
some other file and this is a problem
the linker doesn't know which one to
choose so it's going to throw an error
and you can't really have multiple
definitions for a variable in your c
plus plus program and this is the one
definition rule and the context of
freestanding variables like the weight
here but this is the same in the context
of functions if we go down and put up
our add function here we're going to say
double
a
and double b here and we're going to put
the definition below the main cpp file
let's grab this
we can copy this and put this in the
code here i'm going to remove this
little thing we don't want it we're
going to put in our body and we're going
to return a plus b here okay so this is
our function it is working we can take
out what we had here because it has
served its purpose you can say double
result and we're going to add up 10 and
20 like we did in the last lecture
no problem and we can try and print out
our results here
if we build and run this program it is
going to work without a problem because
we only have one definition for the add
function
what is the problem here we have weight
defined multiple times we're going to
comment out one the definition for
weight
and we're going to build again
now the build is good and we can run
this program we can
kill our terminal here and bring up
another one and run rooster you're going
to see that the result is 30 and the
program is working just fine but if we
set up another definition for add even
if we put this in the same file
we're going to get a problem because we
are violating the one definition rule
let's run again
you're going to see the problem here
we're going to see redefinition
redefinition of the add function this is
not allowed your program is not going to
compile we see the compiler error here
even if you put the definition in
another file that's not going to help
we're going to take this and put this in
our some other file
and try to compile the program
we're going to get a linker error and it
is going to say multiple definition of
the add function and this is not allowed
this is a linker error in this time if
we comment out one definition let's do
that we're going to comment out the one
in the main function this is going to
work and we want to be violating the one
definition rule so this is good the
world is good we can clear
and run rooster we're going to see our
result here so the one definition rule
says you can't have multiple definitions
for
freestanding variables or even functions
and reserve that if you do that you're
going to get a compiler error let's look
at this in the context of classes we're
going to do a class we're going to say
struct and we're going to call this
point like we always do
mostly we're going to call this point
and we're going to put in a few member
variables one is going to be mx the
other is going to be m y
and this is going to be our definition
here
but what you're going to see
is that it is possible to have multiple
definitions for classes for example if
we take this and
have a copy of this in another file
we're going to do that we're going to
declare this structure here
and we're going to try and build this
program you're going to see that it is
working we have multiple definitions of
these guys we can go in main for example
and say point
p1
and we can up weld and see that the
program is going to work okay so if you
go in here for example and try to print
sdd cl
p1 and the print x we're going to do
that we're going to say p1 mx we're
going to be able to use this because
this is a struct the member variables
are public by default we can do this
and we can say
p1 y
is
p1y my let's do that and we can say
stdndl what is the problem here we need
to put our output stream operator
i think now the compiler is going to be
happy
and therefore world
we're going to use gcc
we're going to see that if we run the
program we're going to see our things
here and we have some junk values inside
because these things are not initialized
but if we initialize them to zero using
the braced initialization here
we're going to build again
and we should see zero inside so let's
clear and run rooster now we have 0 in x
and y for our object here this is
working fine and we have multiple
definitions for our class but the
definitions can't show up in a single
translation unit for example if we took
this definition here
and brought that back in main and put
that just below
our structure here if we try to weld the
compiler is going to complain because
now we have multiple definitions for the
same class in the same translation unit
for classes
we can have multiple definitions but the
definitions have to show up in different
translation units and that's what i want
you to see here so we have a
redefinition of our point struct and it
is not good it is going to violate the
one definition rule okay now that you
have seen this we also want to see this
in the context of a class
that also has some static member
variables we're going to take this out
because we have already seen this and
we're going to bring in our person class
like we used in the last lecture we're
going to add in a new header file it's
going to be called person
dot h
and we're going to jump into
what did we do is this folder let's
remove this we didn't want a folder
we're going to delete this folder we
don't want it
and we're going to just add a file
called person.h
that's all file here and we're going to
put in the content the content is going
to be our personal class let's close
this so that you can see more of this
class here okay so we have our person
class here we have our include card we
have our person class definition we have
a constructor and we have a printer
phone function we have our member
variables and down below here you see
that we have a static variable which is
person account we need to put in the
definition for these guys so let's go
down and do that we're going to put in
the definition for the person
constructor we're going to go on top
here and include our person header file
and we're going to put in place our
constructor we can go down and do that
we can say person and say person
that's going to be our constructor we're
going to go back to the class and grab
the parameters because i don't want to
type all these lengths
so let's do that we're going to put them
in
we are going to put in our initializer
list i think we should also delete a
parenthesis here we're going to go down
and put in our initializer list we're
going to say full name we're going to
initialize this with name param
and we're going to also put in our age
and we're going to initialize this with
edge param the parameter we have from
the function and this is going to be all
inside the body we're going to implement
the static variable we're going to say
increment person count okay now select
that here and this is going to be good
we also need to initialize our static
variables so we're going to say ends
person person account let's do person
account and we're going to initialize
this to maybe eight like we did in the
last lecture and this should be all we
need here so if we build and run this
program i think it's going to run
let's select the main function here
and what problem do we have here let's
build and see we're going to let the
compiler figure this out
we're going to see that the world is
good and we can create person objects
and really use them in our program so
let's come down here and delete whatever
we had we're going to include the person
and we're going to go down here and
create a person object we're going to
say person
p1 and we're going to specify the name
to be jon snow why not
and we're going to say that they are
35 why not
and we can preach information about this
person we can say person principle and
if we try to build this program let's
use gcc to do that
the world is going to be good as you see
down here we can clear
and run rooster we're going to see jon
snow he is
35 years old so this is working just
fine but we can't have
multiple definitions for the same class
in the same translation unit here for
example if we come in the main function
notice we are including a person so this
is bringing in the definition for a
person we have in our person.h here if
we also try to declare another class
called person
even if we don't put anything in the
compiler is going to complain because we
have two definitions for the same name
which is person here if we try to build
i think we are going to get a compiler
error saying that we have a definition
you see we have a redefinition of person
so this is not allowed we can't really
do this but notice that this person
class is included both in some other
file which is a separate translation
unit and main we have it included here
so it is really in a separate
translation unit we have the definition
for the class in separate translation
units and that's not a problem but if
you try and put the same definition
multiple times in a single translation
unit you're going to get a problem and
you need to be aware of that what i want
you to see right here is that you can't
also have multiple definitions
for your static variables and the member
functions of your class for example if
we grab what we have here
and also put that in our main function
we can do that why not we're going to
come in our main function here and we're
going to put the same definitions here
now we're going to have a problem
because the linker is going to see two
definitions for the static variable and
the constructor for a person here and
this is going to be a problem you can't
really do that if we build we're going
to see
a problem we're going to see
that the problem is
we have multiple definitions for the
constructor and we have multiple
definitions for person account and this
is not allowed you can't really do that
you can either remove the one from some
other file.cpp for example if we comment
this out
let's do that we can come on top here
and comment this out and try to build
the program now the program is going to
work because we have one definition for
these guys you see the world is good we
can even run the program to show you
that it works or we can remove the one
in the main cpp file and we can leave
this alive so let's go back in the cpp
file the main cpp file i should say and
remove this and if we work we're going
to see that this is going to work and
that we are
compliant with what the c plus plus
standard expects us to do in our c plus
plus programs if we're around we're
going to see that this is going to work
and this is really cool this is really
all i wanted you to see in this lecture
the one definition rule which says that
you can't have multiple definitions for
the same name in your entire c plus plus
program but for classes we can violate
this rule a little bit and make the same
definition show up in multiple
translation units we are going to stop
here in this lecture in the next one
we're going to learn about linkage
go ahead and finish up here and make me
there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about functions a function is a reusable
piece of code that you can use multiple
times to do different things it can take
input and once it has input it can do
some processing and when the processing
is done the function can optionally give
you a result you can think of a function
as a machine which can take input and
give you some output when you give input
to the machine the machine is going to
do some processing and then it's going
to give you the output and the output is
going to be dependent on the input that
you gave to the machine this is really
how a function works in c plus plus and
once you have the machine set up you can
really reuse it however many times you
want let's look at how a function looks
in c plus plus the syntax is this you
first specify the return type which may
be and double or whatever after that
you're going to specify the function
name
and after that you're going to have a
pair of parentheses inside this
parenthesis you're going to have your
parameters which is going to be a comma
separated list of things you pass to the
function and after all these parameters
you're going to have a pair of curly
braces and inside those curly braces
we're going to have the body of the
function we're going to be doing our
processing in the body and when the
processing is done we can get the result
of the function through this return
mechanism here so if we want to get
something out of the function we have to
return that thing and it is going to be
visible to whoever used this function
here is a simple example of a function
with no input and output the syntax is
going to be this void means that this
function is not going to return anything
and you notice that our pair of
parentheses is empty because we have no
input in this function we have our curly
braces and inside these curly braces is
going to be the body of this function
it's going to do some processing and
when processing is done we return out of
this function now remember that i said
that this function doesn't return
anything because it is of void type here
but we can return and i'm going to show
you the exact syntax of how you can do
that okay so we can have many functions
in c plus plus but each function has to
be unique otherwise you're going to have
problems in your c plus plus programs a
function is going to be unique based on
its signature and the signature is
really a function name
plus the function parameters if we go
back to our example here and try to
figure out the signature of this
function it's going to be function name
and plus the parameters and you see that
we have no parameters in here so this
signature is going to uniquely identify
this function in our c plus plus program
if we set up another function that has
this same function name and doesn't take
any parameter we're going to have
problems even if we happen to have a
different return value for the function
and don't worry if this is not making
sense yet we will see a lot of examples
and i am sure by the time we are done
with this lecture you will be a master
at using functions okay now that we have
seen how we can declare or define a
function in c plus plus let's see how we
can use the function
and when you call a function in most
cases you will want to get something out
of that function so suppose here result
var is a variable that is going to catch
the result of the function
and we're going to call the function
with the syntax like this we're going to
say the function name we're going to put
our pair of parentheses here and we are
going to pass in the arguments or of the
values of our parameters this is the
syntax it is going to call the function
and the result of the function is going
to be assigned to this result var
variable of hours here is how you can
call a function that doesn't take any
parameter the parameter list is
basically going to be empty and now
we're going to look at a few examples of
how you can really declare functions in
your c plus plus program for example
here we have a function called into bar
it doesn't return anything so we can't
catch the result of this function and
it's going to have one input in the form
of an integer so the parameter is called
h here it's an integer and inside the
function we are going to test if
somebody is old enough to enter a bar so
we do a test to see if the age is
greater than 18 if it is we're going to
tell them please proceed f the h is not
greater than 18 we're going to tell them
you cannot enter this is an example of a
function you can set up in your c plus
plus programs here is another function
that is going to compute the maximum
between two numbers it is going to give
us a result so the return value is an
integer here the function name is max
and we're going to put in our list of
parameters and again these are the
parameters when you are defining your
function
this comma separated list of things we
have in this parenthesis are called
parameters and when you call the
function the values that you pass in the
places of these parameters are called
arguments so these are a few terms that
can really throw you off and i just want
you to be super clear about these things
once we have the signature of the
function set up we jump in the body and
we do whatever we want this function to
do so we're going to say if a is greater
than b then a must be the maximum we're
going to send it that back to whoever
called this function or in other words
we're going to return a
and if a is not greater than b then b
must be the maximum and we're going to
return it that's what we're saying here
here is another example of a function
that doesn't have any output and doesn't
take any input it doesn't return
anything because the return type is void
and it doesn't take any input because
the parameter list here is empty and the
body of the function we're just going to
greet somebody and tell them hello there
and we're going to return out of the
function notice that for avoid function
we can either omit the return statement
here or we can just put it in like this
say return and the semicolon and
whatever c plus plus compiler you are
using is going to accept this as valid c
plus plus syntax
here is another example of a function
that returns something but doesn't take
any input the return value is going to
be an integer but we don't need to pass
something to this function when we call
it it's just going to give us output we
can call it and get our lucky number and
use that however we want in our c plus
plus application i think we have seen a
lot of examples of how we can set up
functions now let's see how we can call
these functions here is a simple c plus
plus program in the main function we
just set up a few variables a value b
value a and b here and we use those
variables to call functions remember we
set up an inter bar function the
function looked like this and it was
testing to see if somebody's age was
greater than 18. if the age is greater
than 18 they are going to enter the bar
if the edge is not greater than 18 we
won't let them end the function takes
input but it doesn't return anything so
we can call this function like we do
here and say into bar
and you notice that we're not catching
something out of this function we're
just going to call it and we're going to
give it input which is 22 here and the
function is going to do its thing so
it's going to let us in because our age
is greater than 18. down here you see we
are calling the max function here we are
giving it two inputs a value and b value
and it's going to return something and
the return value of this function is
going to be used to initialize this
maximum number variable here this is
what we are doing if we go down we see
that we can call the maximum function
directly and use its return value in an
sddc out statement here and this is
going to print out the maximum between a
and b
and down here you see we have the
function say hello which is going to
just greet somebody and not return
anything here is another example of how
you can call the lucky number you say
lucky number you pass a pair of
parentheses
and this is going to return the lucky
number and print it out in this htdc out
statement here down here we set up a few
variables a and b and we are going to
use them to call the maximum functions
you see we call max a b or we can even
pass in number literals like we are
doing down here
one thing i want you to be careful about
is implicit conversions that might
happen when you are calling you
functions
suppose we have a minimum function like
we see here which is going to be taking
in integer parameters but here we are
calling the function with f and g
which happen to be of double type like
we see on top here so what is going to
happen is the compiler is going to
notice that what you are passing in is
not really what the function takes but
the compiler knows that it can insert a
transformation from double to integer
and it is going to do that without your
involvement so be really careful about
implicit conversions and make sure they
are working to your advantage otherwise
you're going to have really hard to
debug problems in your c plus plus
programs
one other thing i want you to be aware
of is that if we have a function set up
like this this function is going to be
taking parameters as copies so if you
have two variables for example c and d
and you call this function with those
two variables you're not going to be
manipulating those two variables what
you will be working with inside the body
of this function are going to be copies
of the parameters that you passed in
here so if for example you happen to
increment either of the parameters for
example here we increment a and we
increment b
the changes we make here inside the body
of the function are just going to be
affecting copies we have inside the
function here and these copies are going
to die the moment we hit the end of this
function here this is something i want
you to be aware of and we will play with
that in more detail when we hit visual
studio code in a minute here is a simple
example of how you can call that
function we have two variables h and i
and we are going to print them out after
that we're going to call the function
we're going to store the result back in
mult results but the important thing is
that we call the function here with h
and i
remember in the body of the function we
are incrementing h and i as arguments
but the changes we do inside of the body
of the function are not going to be
visible when the function returns if we
print h and i here we're just going to
see the same thing we saw before we call
the function
i realize this is a lot of information
to take in now we are going to head over
to visual studio code and actually play
with us step by step
okay here we are in our working
directory the chapter is on functions
the current lecture is first hand on
functions we are going to grab our
template files like we always do we're
going to put this on
and we are going to open this in visual
studio code let's open the folder
and we are going to go in the correct
chapter
and choose first hand on functions here
this is what we want to open and we are
going to open our main cpp file and
clean it up a little bit
and the first thing we want to do is to
set up a function that takes a single
parameter and doesn't give back any
result so the function is going to be
interbore we have seen that the function
is not going to return anything so it's
going to be void its return type is
going to be void the name of the
function is going to be interbar and
what we want to pass in here is a
variable to represent the age of
somebody and we know that the age can
really not be negative so it is
advised to at least use an unsigned
integer type so we're going to use
unsigned end and the parameter name is
going to be called age
once we have our parameter list we're
going to put in the function body and
remember the function body is going to
leave within these two
curly braces
now this is a valid c plus plus function
it's not going to return anything it's
going to take a single parameter whose
type is unsigned and its name is
interbar we can get inside the function
and actually do whatever it is we want
to do so once we go in we're going to
test and see if the age is greater than
18 do something if the age is not
greater than 18 we're going to do
something else let's do that we're going
to say if
age is greater than 18 we're going to
tell them the age and tell them that
they can actually go in this is logical
and we're going to say else and in the
body of this else block
we're going to say something else
we're going to tell them sorry you are
too young for this and we are going to
get out of this block here and this is
really our function again let's try to
analyze the syntax here we have the
return type this is required in c plus
plus if you don't put it in you're going
to get a compiler error because you
can't have a function without a return
type in c plus plus you notice that we
have our squiggly lines here visual
studio code is not happy so we're going
to tell it the return type we're going
to save the function name after that
and after the function name we're going
to pass the parameters we can have any
number of parameters or inputs to the
function but in this case we just have
one because it is enough for our
purposes after that we have the body and
inside the body we do whatever it is we
want to do in this function here because
this function returns void we don't
really need to explicitly return from
this function here but this is an
exception only for functions that return
void for other return types you will
have to put in the return statement but
even for void functions you can put the
return statement if you want and you can
do that like this say return
and you're going to put a semicolon
after this this is also valid c plus
plus syntax okay now we have declared
the function it is a valid c plus plus
functions let's try and call it we're
going to go down in main because that's
where we want to be calling our
functions for now and we are going to
say interbar we're going to call the
function and you use the function name
to call it and you're going to put in a
pair of parentheses and pass an argument
to the function again what you pass to
the function when you call it it's
called an argument but what you pass
through the function when you are
defining it like we did here that's a
parameter
okay so function parameters when
declaring functions and when you are
calling the function what you pass are
function
arguments and now we need to pass in
some age to this function and let's say
22 and if we do that this is going to be
a valid c plus plus program
notice that we have this squiggly line
it is because we forgot a semicolon here
because
c plus plus requires to have a semicolon
after each statement and now we have a
valid c plus program that is declaring a
function and calling a function down
here in main we can try to build it
let's use gcc to do that the world is
going to be good you see world finished
successfully and we can bring up a
terminal and actually try to run this
function here let's clear and run
rooster because our program is going to
be called rooster like we have been
doing all along and at the output is
going to be you are 22
please proceed notice that we have this
function defined once but we can call it
multiple times so for example if you go
down here and say into bar
and we give it 15 as the age
and we try and build again let's build
with gcc
the builder is going to be good we can
clear and run rooster now it's going to
say you are 15 please proceed why is
that
what are we really doing here uh if age
is greater than 10 we say 10 here we
should say 18. sorry for this we're
going to weld again
and now it should behave accordingly so
let's say rooster here
you are 22 please proceed you are too
young for this no offense because the
age is 15 here you can keep calling this
function and you're going to see things
printing out you can even call this
function in the loop i can't really
resist so let's do that we're going to
say for size t
i and say start from 0 for example or 1
why not
and we are going to say while i is less
than
10 or
20. we're going to increment uh you
already know how to use loops so we're
going to be using this as an example
and we can
comment out all these guys in front
because we don't want them to print
stuff by now
and what we're going to do is call the
function with whatever iteration we are
at
notice that we have a size t here and
the function is going to be taken
an unsigned integer so we're going to
have implicit conversions from size t
to end or if we really want this to not
cause any problems we can change the
type of our parameter to be size t this
is also valid c plus plus code let's say
size t properly
and if we go down here
we're going to say
enter bar
and we're going to pass an i
watch what is going to happen this is
going to loop
from 1 all the way to 19 and it's going
to be calling this function with
whatever iteration we might be at so
it's going to look from 1 all the way to
18 and it's going to
tell us we are too young for this but
for 19 it's going to let us in because
we will be old enough to enter a bar
let's try this i think it's going to be
fun we're going to weld with gcc
and we're going to clear
and run rooster ah sorry you're too
young for this you too young with us and
that once we hit 19 it's going to tell
us we are young enough to enter a bar
and we're going to go and and have as
much fun as we want so this is really
how you can declare a function remember
a function is uniquely identified by its
signature and the signature is really
the name of the function and the
parameters that you have in here okay
once you have the function declared
you're going to do whatever you want in
the body you are going to optionally
return something from the function and
once the function is declared or set up
you can go in main and call it and do
whatever it is you want with it okay now
i think we are mature enough to try out
a few other functions let's go down and
put in another function which is going
to compute the maximum of two numbers
the signature of this function is going
to be its name here and the parameters
notice that we are taking two parameters
because we want to be computing the
maximum between two numbers and this
function is going to return something we
want to get the maximum out of the
function and use it to do something else
when we call it
so this is the declaration of the
function once we hit the body of the
function we are going to compute the
maximum we're going to say if a is
greater than b then a must be our
maximum so we're going to return that
and if a is not greater than b then b
must be the maximum we're going to
return b as our maximum here this is
what the function is doing we can go in
main and call it let's go down and
comment this out because we don't want
noise output from these guys so calling
interbore that's what we were doing now
we are calling max so we're going to go
down and set up a variable call it
result why not and we're going to
compute the maximum between 10 and 20
why not okay so let's see what we get
and we're going to print the maximum
this time we're going to say
max as resort okay now if we build this
program and run it try to guess what
we're going to get we're going to call
the maximum function
and what we pass in here are arguments
again we are not passing parameters here
we are going to pass in 10 and 20 as our
arguments and when we call the function
control is going to jump to the body of
the function and we are going to fall
inside here the arguments we're going to
pass in are just going to be copied in
the function and we will have them
through these names a and b so we're
going to test and see if the first
parameter is greater than the second in
this case the first parameter is not
greater than the second because the
first one is 10 the second is a 20.
let's go down and see that and the test
here is going to fail and we're going to
run whatever is in the else block here
and we are going to return b as our
maximum when we return b
b is going to basically be the result of
this expression here
and that result is going to be assigned
to our research variable and we're going
to print it out with this sddc out
statement here so let's try and build
this we're going to build with gcc again
the world is going to be good we're
going to clear and run rooster you see
that maximum is 20. if we try and change
this for example make the first
parameter 100 and both again
let's see what maximum we get
going to clear and run rooster we're
going to say that maximum is 100 and
again you can call this function however
many times you want for example we can
call it again and say result equals
max using two variables that we have
let's say x and y
and go on top and declare these two
variables why not we're going to say and
x and we're going to put in it 22
and we're going to say end y and put in
a 44 right now
and now if we print the result we're
going to get 44 because that's the
maximum that was assigned back to our
research variable here let's weld again
we're going to run the task to build
with gcc
you can clear and run rooster you see
max is 44 and this is really how you can
declare and use a maximum function like
this
we're going to comment this out because
we have a few more functions we want to
try out let's go on top and put in
another function and again notice that
we are declaring functions
before the main function here this is a
requirement of a c plus plus compiler
because before you use the function the
function must be declared somewhere so
we need to go before the main function
and declare our functions here the
function we're going to do now is say
hello here it's not going to take any
input and it's not going to give us any
output it's just going to say hello and
die off we can go down and call it this
is going to be super easy calling hello
and we're going to call it say hello see
that even visual studio code knows about
this function we can call it like this
it's going to be activated so we're
going to hit the body of the function
we're going to say hello there and the
function is going to return or die off
please know that you could omit this
return statement for functions that
return void so if we comment this guy
out the function is going to work
equally well you can use this however
you want now we're just going to build
with gcc and see this function run
the build is good we're going to run
rooster and it is saying hello there
let's go down and look at another
example here
the next function is going to be lucky
number it's not going to take any input
but it is going to give us an output in
the form of an integer so we can call it
let's go down and comment out saying
hello here and say that we want to call
lucky number
and we can go down and set up a variable
let's do that we're going to say int
result
and we
are going to brace initialize this guy
so it's going to be initialized to zero
and we're going to say result
equals lucky number and we're going to
take the result returned by our lucky
number function and assign that to the
result variable and we can print it out
if we want so we can say sddc out and
say result
and we're going to put that out here say
result
and if we build and run this program
we're going to get this guy printed out
we should see a 99 because that's what
we are returning from our function here
and resort is 99 as you see in the
output here so this is really how you
can declare
your functions a function has a unique
signature so for example into bar here
has this particular name
and these parameters here
if you go down mats has its own name and
the parameters that it takes in if you
go down say hello and lucky number are
different in their own ways if you try
and set up another function that has the
same signature as max here your compiler
is going to freak out let's try and do
that we're going to set up another
function it's going to have a void
return type we're going to call it max
because we want to match this signature
here
and we're going to give it two
parameters into a and it b
and we can do whatever we want in this
function notice that we have a squiggly
line if we open our problems tab here
you're going to see that visual studio
code has a few problems with this
because we are setting up a function
with the same signature twice let's try
and different make this a net and see
what we get right now we don't seem to
have a problem but if we get to run this
program we're going to have problems
let's go down and actually activate the
code to call the max function to really
show you this
because you need to know so we're going
to comment out calling lucky number and
we want to call max we're going to
activate the code to call max
and we are going to build this with gcc
notice what we're going to see uh-huh we
have problems here we have a compiler
error saying re definition of int max
and ant
and
one might think what if i name my
parameters differently here for example
i call this guy
c
and this other guy d
let's do that
using different names like this is not
going to solve your troubles because if
we try and uh bold again we're going to
get the same compiler error this is not
going to change your thing we don't have
enough tools to really understand this
problem but know that you can't have two
functions
with the exact same signature in a
single c plus plus program and we're
going to learn more about this later but
note that the signature of a function
must be unique to it throughout your
entire c-plus program if you remember
this simple rule you're not going to
have many problems so let's try and weld
again to make sure we have no more
problems in here
the bolt is good and we can run the
program to see our maximum printed out
so let's do that clear
rooster and max is 44 it is exactly what
we expect
the last thing i want to do in this
lecture is make it super clear in your
mind that what we pass to functions we
have been setting up so far
are copies so let's go on top and set up
a simple function the function is going
to increment and multiply it returns a
double type the name of the function is
increment and multiply and it is going
to take two parameters and a double a
and a double b
once we hit the body of the function
we're going to increment a and b
the arguments that were passed to the
function and we're going to multiply
them and we're going to store the result
of that in a reserved variable the
result variable is what we're going to
return to the function and whoever
called this function is going to use
that to do whatever they want what we
really want to see is that the changes
we do inside the function are not going
to be visible to the arguments that we
pass to this function here to really
make this super clear let's go down in
main and set up a few variables we're
going to have a double h and the double
i the values are going to be three and
four we're going to print them out and
we're going to call our increment
multiply function notice that we pass h
and the i
to the function and the result of the
function is going to be stored in uh the
anc mult resort variable here but the
return value is really not important
what we want to see
is if the changes we do to the arguments
are going to be visible on the outside
of the function here so remember we have
h and i here we pass them to the
function once we hit the inside of the
function
we're going to increment a and b
and we are going to return from the
function so let's see
if a which was a 3 and b which was a 4
have been incremented to 4 and 5. that's
what we want to see so we're going to
boil this and run this so let's use gcc
to do that the bulk is going to be good
we're going to clear
and run rooster
and notice what we have here let's go
down and look at the variables again
we set up h to contain a 3 so before we
increment h
and i are four
okay so that's what we're going to print
here once we hit the inside of the
function
we are going to say what we have inside
the function before we do the operation
before the increment again a and b are
four so these are copies we have inside
we're going to
do the increment and after we have the
increment a and b are going to be four
but once we hit the outside of the
function
and a print
with this guy here we're going to see
that h and i
are still three and four so
we didn't really affect h and i when we
did this increment here what we affected
are copies that were passed to a and b
here
and this is something you need to know
because some people will think that
because i pass
h and i in my argument list here i can
manipulate h and i what you are
manipulating are copies that were made
by the compiler to pass the arguments to
the function here this is something you
need to keep in mind and we will learn
more about this but i wanted you to
learn this firsthand and this is really
all we set out to do in this lecture i
hope you have a better understanding of
what a function is and what you can do
with it in c plus plus we are going to
stop here in this lecture in the next
one we're going to learn a little more
about function declarations and function
definitions
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about function declarations and
function definitions the motivation for
the topic we're going to be talking
about here is that sometimes you really
want to separate a function header from
its implementation because you don't
want to expose all the details about how
you do stuff let's look at the simple
example in the last lecture we declared
a max function which was computing the
maximum between two numbers the output
was an integer so that's what we
returned the name of the function was
max and we had two parameters into a and
and b but what we did in the last
lecture was crop the entire function
body
in front of main but sometimes people
don't want to really see the details of
how you do stuff they just want to know
a summary of what your function does
what we can get out of the function and
what we need to give to the function for
it to do its job and that's what we're
going to see in this lecture if you look
here we have the function header in
front of the main function and the
function header is made up of its return
type the name of the function and the
list of the parameters and after that
we're going to put a semicolon this is
called a function header or a prototype
and when we do that the compiler is
going to be happy and it's going to work
with us to compile our program but when
we get to link our program to really put
it together and make one binary the
definition of the function is going to
be needed and if you look after main
here what we have is a function
definition if you look closely you see
that it is exactly the same thing we had
in the last lecture we have our header
information we don't have a semicolon
after our parameter list but we have a
pair of curly braces and inside these
curly braces we have the body of our
function
now
it is really easy to look at this
program because we don't have to look at
all these details about how this
function works we can get
first-hand information on how we can use
this function and that is what most
people are going to be interested in
about your function they want to really
want to go in and see how you do stuff
they will want to use your function to
get the output and use it to do whatever
it is they want to do if you look here
in the body of the main function we have
two variables a and b and we use them to
call the maximum function we can also
set up a minimum function which works in
the similar way and we call another
function called increment which is going
to increment and multiply whatever
arguments we pass to this function so
the main idea here is that we can split
our function in two parts one is going
to be the function header which is
really going to be the function
declaration and the other is going to be
the function body with all the details
about how the function works and that's
going to be our function definition and
once we have these two things in place
we can call the function in our main
function and do whatever we want with
that okay now it should be super clear
that we can separate our function in two
parts declaration and definition and
sometimes the declaration part is also
called a prototype that's a prototype of
a function and it is made up of the
return type
together with the function name together
with the parameters and after that
you're going to add a semicolon to make
it valid c plus syntax and another thing
you should know is that the prototype
needs to come before wherever it is
called if you're trying to call a
function before its prototype is seen in
your c plus plus program you're going to
get a compiler error and now you might
be asking but why did our programs in
the last lecture work we didn't split
things up and our program was working
fine
well
if you put a function definition in
front of the main function that function
definition is also going to double as a
function declaration that's why the code
in the last lecture worked okay now that
you have an idea about what a function
declaration and the function definition
is let's head over to visual studio code
and play with us okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
function declarations and definitions we
are going to grab our templates files
like we always do
we're going to put them in place
and we are going to open this guy in
visual studio code let's do that
we open this up
and we are going to open our main cpp
file clean it up a little bit and let's
close this pane so that we have some
breathing space the first thing we're
going to do is set up a maximum function
you already know how to do that we're
going to specify the return type
we are going to specify the function
name and the parameters we're going to
take in it a and into b and we're going
to go in and do whatever we need to
compute the maximum between these two
guys we're going to say if a is greater
than b
then
a must be the maximum so we're going to
return that
else we are going to return
b
okay this is the function and it is
really simple we can go down in main and
use it so let's say ant
x and i put in a five for example
and let's say
y and put in a two or a three put in
whatever you want
and then we're going to set up the
research variable
which is going to catch the maximum i
think we can do that and what we're
going to assign to this is whatever is
returned from our function call so we're
going to call this function with x and y
so we're going to be computing the
maximum between
5 and 2 here the maximum is going to be
stored in this result variable and we're
going to print it out so we're going to
say std
see out and i'm going to say max
as result this is going to do
okay let's try and build this and make
sure it actually works
this is nothing new so far it is
everything we have done in the last
lecture
now the world is good we can clear and
run rooster we're going to get the
maximum as a five here and if we try to
change this things for example make y 12
and world again
we're going to use gcc
and we are going to clear these thanks
and run rooster we should get max equals
12.
this is all fine and dandy but sometimes
we don't really want to have the details
about how our function works shown in
front of the main function here and we
can split our function in two parts a
declaration and a definition the
declaration is really going to be the
header part of the function and that's
going to be the return value the name of
the function and the parameter list but
to make it a valid declaration we have
to put a semicolon after this so this is
our function
declaration
sometimes it is also called a prototype
and please make sure you understand the
difference between a prototype and a
signature in the last lecture we saw
that the signature was only made of the
name of the function and the parameter
list but the return value was not part
of the function signature but the
prototype includes all these guys so
signature doesn't include
return type
okay so now that we have our function
declaration setup we need to put in
a function definition because if you try
to compile this program and link it
you are going to get problems let's try
and do that before we put in the
definition
we can weld with gcc we are learning so
we don't
have to fear breaking things a little
bit
let's clear and try to build with gcc
and you're going to see ah we have a
problem here and what kind of problem we
have the c plus plus compiler is going
to compile this program but when we hit
the link stage
i realize i haven't really talked about
this in more detail but we will do in
this lecture but the main problem here
is that we don't have the definition of
this function in place and the compiler
is going to search for it and not find
it and you see that it is saying
undefined reference to max
okay so it has seen the declaration of
the function
but it doesn't know how the function
does its job because we don't have a
function body in here so to really make
this code work exactly as we want we
need to put in a definition and the
definition can show up anywhere in your
c plus plus program in this case we're
going to put that
after the main function and the
definition is really
what we have been using so far as our
function definition in the last lecture
but notice that it has the body
information and now when the compiler
tries to compile this program it will
know how the maximum function is
computing its maximum because we have
all that information in here so let's
say that this is our function definition
and shows up after main in this case and
we can try and build this and see if the
work is good now you see the world is
good
and if we try to run it we're going to
get our maximum exactly like we did when
we had
the declaration and the definition
cramped up before main here but
hopefully now you can see that our
program is much cleaner because when you
look at this you know that we have a
function called max it's going to take
two parameters it's going to return
something and it is called mats so it
must be computing the maximum of these
two guys but we don't really care how
this function does its job how it
computes the maximum here and this is
the main message here we can split a
function in two parts a declaration and
a definition okay just to play around we
can also set up a minimum function
before we do that let's set up its
definition down here we're just going to
copy the maximum and adapt it
we're going to put a copy of that guy
here we're going to call it men
it's going to take two parameters it's
going to return an end but what we test
for is if a is less than b if a is less
than b then a is a minimum
if a is not less than b then b must be
our minimum and we can put the
declaration of this function on top here
so let's go there and say men
and say end a and end b
and now we can change the call here to
say mean and it is going to compute the
minimum why not let's do that we're
going to say min here and we're going to
grab whatever is the minimum between x
and y here and that's what we're going
to have in this result variable here
let's do that we're going to try and use
this
the build is good
so we're going to clear and run rooster
now the minimum is five we are calling
our minimum function
in the last lecture we also set up a
function to increment and multiply let's
try and do the same thing
but split that into a declaration and
the definition just to practice a little
more we're going to call this and
malt and it's going to take a and b in
and inside and we're not going to put
the body on top here we're going to put
the body down with the other definitions
that we have for all these other
functions for max and mean here so we're
going to put in our body it's really
simple so we're going to put a body
inside this curly braces
and we are going to return
plus a
we're going to increment a
and we're going to multiply that with an
increment of b
and we're going to return that i think
this is going to be valid c plus plus
syntax and if we try to call this
function in main let's do that say in
mult and we're going to pass an x and y
the program is going to just work fine
we're going to grab the result and store
that
in our variable let's do that
and we can print the result
and we're going to say result here this
is going to do
and if we build and run this program
we're going to see the output here let's
see what we get
the results is going to be 78 because if
we increment a 5 it becomes a 6.
if we increment y we're going to get 13
13 times 6 should be 78 let's be sure
we're going to bring up the calculator
let's do that so that you know that i am
not making these things up 78. so our
program is really working like it should
and this is the main message here we can
really split up functions into a
declaration
and a definition and that's going to
make our programs much easier to work
with and read
one thing you should know is that the
names of the variables aren't really
important in function declarations like
this
so for example we can take out the a and
b here
or we can take out all the variable
names in our function declarations let's
do that
and you might think is this program
going to compile well i hate to break it
to you but it is going to compile so
let's weld with gcc
you're going to see that the both is
good so the function header or
declaration doesn't really care about
the variable names
in the definitions we care about these
variable names because we are going to
be using them in the bodies but if you
want you can leave them out in your
function declarations but i like to keep
them in place because i like my
functions to be self-documented if
somebody looks at this they will know
the variable name here but if you really
want you can leave the variable names
out and it is going to work pretty well
this is really always enough to do in
this lecture i hope you found it
interesting we are going to stop here in
this lecture in the next one we are
going to see how we can split our
programs in multiple files now that we
know how to split into declaration and
definition
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to revisit
our c plus plus program compilation
model along the way we are also going to
see how we can work with functions
across multiple files
if you remember our compilation model
looked something like this you have seen
this slide a lot of times by now what it
describes is what happens when we
compile our program the moment we run
the compilation command our c plus
program which lives in the main cpp file
by now is going to be passed through the
compiler the compiler is going to
process it and it is going to come up
with a binary executable that is mostly
called rooster in this course and when
we execute this rooster file or binary
file we're going to get the program to
run the program is going to be executed
instruction by instruction when it is
loaded by the operating system and we
are mostly going to see the output of
that program on the terminal in this
course this is the compilation model we
know but now what we want to do is zoom
in on this compilation part here and see
what really happens under the hood
we are going to suppose that we have a
program which is made of a lot of source
files as we have here on the left
suppose we have two three or five source
files unlike what we have so far which
is one file the main cpp file when you
compile such a program you're going to
go through a stage called
pre-processing and what this is going to
do
it's going to look for your include
statement
and it is going to take whatever file
you are including and it is going to
paste that in place so for example here
you see we have an include io stream
statement
when the pre-processing stage is run
this includes statement is going to be
replaced with whatever we have in this
io stream file here so this is going to
be wiped out and we're going to put in
the content that we have in io stream in
this exact place where we have the
include statement i hope this is clear
so when we go through preprocessing
we're going to have
a version of our source files
with the included parts put in our
source files we're basically going to go
copy everything in that file that we
include and we're going to paste inside
our new files here that we're going to
be referring to as translation units by
now these are translation units in a c
plus plus program
once you have this translation unit then
you're going to compile them they are
going to go through the compiler the
compiler is going to generate what we
call an object file and this is a binary
representation of the content you have
in your translation unit so each
translation unit is going to generate
one object file and for example if you
had 20 translation units in your program
you're going to have 20 object files
once we have object files they are going
to be processed by what we call the
linker
and the linker is going to stitch them
together and have one single binary file
out of all these object files so we're
going to have something like this and
this is basically going to be our binary
that we can run on our target operating
system so by now you see that our
compilation model has expanded to
contain three phases we have
pre-processing compilation and linking
now you might be asking why am i showing
you this now well it is going to matter
because we're going to split to a
program across multiple files some of
those files are going to matter on the
compilation phase and some of those
files are going to matter on the linking
stage so we really need to make a clear
distinction between the compilation and
linking here okay this should be a more
complete compilation model to go by for
now now that we know about this
compilation model we can look at how we
can split our program across multiple
files suppose we have three functions
one we can use to get the maximum of two
numbers called max a function called men
we can use to get the minimum between
two numbers and a function we can use to
increment and multiply like we have seen
in the last lecture now the two
functions maths and men are going to
live in their own file and that file is
going to be split in two files we're
going to have a header file and a cpp
file which is going to contain the
implementation in the header what we're
going to have is just a prototype and we
are going to set up our code in a way
that our anchor mult function here is
going to live in zone file we're going
to split that in two files so we're
going to have a header file called
operations.h
and we're going to have an
implementation file called
operations.cpp
which is going to contain the
implementation of this function here
when we hit the main file what we're
going to do is nothing special we're
just going to include the headers and we
are going to use these functions like we
have been using them all along if you
look on the first line here we are
calling max on the second line we are
calling men and on the third line here
we are calling incur mult to do whatever
it does okay when you start splitting
your functions between the definitions
and the declarations remember the one
definition rule and this says that you
can't have a function defined
multiple times in your entire c-plus
class application if you do that the
lincoln stage is going to find those two
functions and it's going to
not know which one you really want to
use and you're going to get a linker
error we're going to see that when we
hit visual studio code in a minute
another thing is that you know that your
definition can really leave anywhere in
your code
the linker is smart enough to parse your
entire project looking for
the definition for whatever function
it's found in your source code and it's
going to keep looking until it finishes
looking in all translation units and
when it doesn't find the definition it's
going to give you a link error which is
probably going to say undefined
reference to something and we're going
to see an example of this in a minute
okay now that you know about this
updated compilation model and you have
an idea that we can split our functions
across multiple files we're going to
head over to visual studio code and play
with us
okay here we are in our working folder
the current project is multiple files
here we're going to grab our template
files let's copy that
and put that in the project of interest
and we're going to open this in visual
studio code let's do that we're going to
open the folder i'm going to choose the
project and open it
and we are going to open up the main cpp
file here
and clean it up a little bit we are
going to set up a max function and
remember the function has to show up
before it is used somewhere
and uh we are going to split this into a
definition and a declaration i think we
already know how to do that so let's do
that we're going to
put a definition down here and we're
going to change what we have on top here
into a declaration let's say that to be
super clear and what we have down here
is a definition and we can call this
function we're going to set up the
variable which is going to store our max
for example
and we're going to assign whatever we
get from the function
to max here so we want to find the
maximum between 34 and 56 for example
and we're going to print this out i'm
going to say max is the maximum
and if we boil and run this program
let's use gcc to do that we have a
compiler error here what is that we need
a semicolon not a column here
i think the squiggly line is now going
to go away and our things are named the
same way the compiler is not going to
like it let's bring up a terminal so
that we see our problems tab expression
preceding parentheses or parallel must
have
ah okay the problem here is that these
two guys max and max are called
the same and this is going to confuse
the compiler a little bit so what we're
going to do is call this maximum
no big deal here
and we're going to do maximum here
and the compiler is going to be happy
now we can compile and i've built this
program world is good and if we run it
we should get our maximum printed out
let's see that the maximum is 56
and if we change 34 here to be 134
and both again we should grab that as
the maximum let's see if that's the case
here
run the program the maximum is 134.
so this is working exactly as we want
the next thing we want to do is to split
this function across multiple files so
we're going to set up two different
files one is going to be a header file
the other is going to be a cpp file and
you have to follow this structure in c
plus so we're going to go on the left
here and add a new file in visual studio
code you can click on this little icon
that says new file to create a new file
once you do that you're going to be
given this little window in which we can
type the name of the file we're going to
call this compare
dot h it's going to be our header file
and we're going to add another one which
is going to say compare that cpp okay
our two files are going to be compare
that h and compare that cpp
and they are going to contain
our functions to compare stuff so we're
going to have in a function called max
and another function called men for
computing the minimum let's go there and
actually do that we're going to move our
declaration in the header file
so your declarations are going to be
leaving in header files and we're going
to grab our definition and move that
in another file called
compare.cpp so i'm just going to cut it
out and paste that and compare cpp here
once we do that we're going to go back
in main
and see that we have a problem now
the main function doesn't know what this
max function is because it's not
declared anymore and if we're trying to
compile our program we're basically
going to get the same error we see here
and visual studio code identifier max is
undefined because it doesn't know what
this function is if we ignore this and
try to weld let's do that we are
learning so no big deal here we're going
to get an even
much weirder error but the message is
going to be the same maths was not
declared in the scope so the compiler
doesn't know what to do with whatever we
typed here but there is a way in c plus
plus we can solve this problem by
including the header that contains our
declaration for the function that we are
using here we can go back in main and do
that and we're going to say include and
we're going to say compare
that h
that's going to bring in our header and
if you wait a minute you're going to see
that the squiggly line is going to go
away so what happened the preprocessor
is going to come in and copy whatever we
have inside compare.h it's basically
going to go and compare that age copy
everything we have in here and come back
in main and paste all that in the place
where we have the include directive here
this is called an include directive or
an include preprocessor directive this
is what the preprocessor is going to do
here and now if we try to build this
program let's try to do that we should
be fine world finished successfully and
we can run our program to see the
maximum printed out let's run rooster
maximum is 134 now everything is working
let's add another function here because
just having one function is really
boring so we're going to put in a main
function it's going to type into a and
into b
and we're going to go in the cpp file
and put in another definition for the
minimum function here we're going to
call this man
let's do that
let's call this man and we're going to
test for a is less than b this is going
to give us a minimum and now if we go
back in main cpp we will be able to use
our minimum function because it is
protein also by this preprocessor
directive we have here so we can go down
and say end minimum and we're going to
say man
and let's grab
and 23 why not and we're going to print
the minimum here and we're going to
build this with gcc
the bullet is going to be good if we run
this we should see both the maximum and
the minimum from these calls we make
here
okay by now you should have an idea
about how to split your functions across
multiple files you should also know that
you will have to include whatever header
contains the declarations for the
functions that you want to use another
thing i want you to see is that the
definitions for your functions don't
have to live in a file that is named the
same as the header file for example here
our header file is called compare and
the comparison tpp contains our
definitions but the definitions don't
have to live here they can really live
in any translation unit that you have in
your c plus plus program
and our c plus plus programs the
translation unit is mostly equivalent to
a cpp file so let's set up another file
and show you that we can move this
definition there and the program is
going to keep working we're going to add
another cpp file and call it some
other file
that cpp it has to be a cpp file because
it's going to contain the
implementations and let's take the
implementations for example let's take
them all put them in another file why
not
we're going to grab all these guys here
let's catch them out and put them in
some other file
and i'm going to build this and see that
it works it should
because the linker is smart enough to go
find these definitions
and whatever translation units that we
have set up in our project here and you
see the world is good we can upload this
we can run this i should say and we're
going to have our output here we can
even take one of these guys let it leave
in our
compare.cpp file for example let's take
the minimum function here
and we're going to bring that
back and we're going to work notice that
now
our maximum function is living in some
other file and that the minimum function
definition is leaving and compare that
cpp but if we will this is going to work
again the linker is
going to parse all the translation units
looking for whatever
definition it needs to find and in this
case it will be looking for the maximum
here and it's going to find that in some
other file and for the
minimum function here it's going to be
looking and compare and it is going to
find it and the world is going to be
good and we can run the program again
and see our output here
one thing i really need to point out is
that if the definition is not available
let's say the minimum function here is
not there we can comment it out to hide
it to the compiler or hide it from the
compiler
and if we try to vote now
we will get a linker error let's try to
build with gcc
uh-huh world finished with errol's the
terminal process terminated with execute
code -1 but the main message here is
that we have an undefined reference to
min and and so when we compile the
compiler is going to be happy with the
declarations that it has found in our
compare.h file if we go there we see
that we have a declaration for max and
the declaration for man the compiler is
going to be happy it's going to compile
our code and when the compiler compiles
it's going to generate object files and
it will hand the job over to the linker
to stitch all those little object files
together to have one single binary file
once the linker tries to do that it's
going to look at main because that's
where it's mostly going to start from
and it's going to see uh-huh main is
calling minimum here where is the
definition for the minimum function it's
going to parse every single translation
unit in the project it's going to come
here and compare that cpp it's not going
to find it it's going to look in
main.cpp it's not going to find it it's
going to look in some other file it's
not going to find the definition and the
linker is going to say
i didn't find my definition for the
minimum function so i'm going to throw a
linker error and you the developer
you're going to fix this problem and
you're going to see this error here and
again this is a linker error gcc doesn't
give you
more visible stuff to show you that this
is a linker error but what you should
look for is ld returned 1 here because
ld is the linker that gcc uses so this
is a linker error
i think i should show you how a linker
error looks if you are using a microsoft
compiler so we're going to build again
but now we're going to build with msvc
if you don't have visual studio that's
not a problem you can keep using gcc but
i just want you to see how different
compilers handle these arrows i have the
luxury to do that because i am
developing this course on a windows
machine and i have a microsoft compiler
handy that we can use directly from
visual studio code here so i am going to
choose this compiler
and you're going to see that it is going
to start welding it is building
and it is going to fail and throw a link
arrow also so you see here some other
object file okay
when
this object file was being taken and
stitched together with other object
files to put together a binary it didn't
find the definition for the minimum
function and it is going to throw a
linker error and in visual studio you're
going to have a problem like this l and
k
and it's going to give whatever version
of the compiler you are using but down
here you see unresolved external symbol
this is how visual studio says it and
it's basically going to be
an undefined reference to something this
is just visual studio's compiler's way
to say this and again it's going to say
this is a linker error here
it is basically the same error we saw
when we were using gcc in a minute video
studio the compiler from microsoft is
also going to put a lot of junk in our
folder here so let's remove all these
things i'm going to select them all
and i hate to delete here
and they are going to go to my recycle
bin and we have another one here we
should remove let's remove it
and now we should go back in some other
file.cpp or compare.cpp that's where we
have a minimum function we can activate
it and if we're both now the world
should be good because the linker is
going to find this definition here
okay let's build with gcc because that's
my favorite compiler
now you see that the world is good we
can clear and run rooster and our
program is going to work as it should
this is really how you can split your
functions across multiple files the
headers are going to contain the
declarations the cpp files are going to
contain the definitions your definitions
can really leave anywhere it's going to
be a matter of what works better for
your project but for organizational
purposes your cpp files are going to be
basically like this you're going to have
some declarations in the header like
compare.h
and in a corresponding cpp file you're
going to have and the definitions for
whatever declarations you have in the
header but you don't have to do it this
way if it makes sense for your
definition to show up somewhere else
please go ahead and do that c plus plus
is going to accept that this is really
all we set out to do in this lecture but
before we go i'm going to give you a
chance to set up another function
suppose we have a function called
anchor malt and we're going to have the
function set up in here we're going to
return
a plus plus
we already know how to do these things
we've used this example a couple of
times by now plus plus b
and that's what we're going to return
now your job is to split this function
into
a declaration and a definition and put
those in two separate files one is going
to be called operations.h and the other
is going to be called
operations.cpp pause the video go ahead
set up your project like that and call
that function in main cpp and see if you
can pull that together okay post the
video do that and once you are done come
back again and see how i do this so
we're going to set up a new file called
operations here
it's going to be a header file dot h and
we're going to add another file called
operations.cpp
that's going to be our cpp file which is
going to contain our definitions we're
going to go back in main and grab the
entire function here we don't want it in
main so we're going to go in
the header here
we should go in the operations header
that's where we want this
and we're going to put in our definition
and we're going to put in our
declaration the declaration doesn't have
a body so we're just going to put a
semicolon at the end here you already
know this we're going to go in the cpp
file and put in our definition
this is going to work and to be able to
use this function
we will need to include the
corresponding header here why is this
file called
uh it's called ccp
it's cpp we're going to rename it
and we're going to change this to cpp
now we should be fine we should have our
thanks colored
properly and uh to use this function we
will need to include the corresponding
header which is operations.h
let's do that we're going to go in main
and go down and include
operations
dot h this is going to work
and notice that the way we include our
own headers is different from the way we
include
the libraries or headers that come with
the c plus plus standard library this is
a conversion that is used by many
compilers this is how we will have to do
things please remember this if you are
including your own header please put
that
in the quotes like we do here if you are
including a standard library header
please use angle brackets like this now
that we have this
included we can go down here and say
result
we're going to set up two variables x
and y
why not we're going to have a 4 here
and we're going to have a y which is a
five let's do that and we're going to
have an integer to store our results
it's going to say anchor mount and it's
going to do the operations on x
and y let's do that and we're going to
print the results here so we're going to
say result
and it's going to be whatever we have in
that variable
okay if we build this program it is
going to work we're going to use gcc to
world the world is good if we run it we
should
see our output here going to run rooster
and the result is 24 because
okay if we increment x we're going to
get a 5
and if we increment a 5 we're going to
get a 6.
if we multiply these guys we should get
a 30 and that's not what we have here so
what is happening let's look at our
definition here
ah we said a plus plus
we should say plus plus a
because we want to increment immediately
okay let's build again
we are going to
well successfully
and we are going to clear and run
rooster now we have the result that we
expect let's go back in main and look at
our program this is what we are using
here and this is the output we expect
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture showing you how you can
set up your project to split
functions across multiple files this is
really good if you want to organize your
project for example somebody who comes
to the header here is not going to be
bothered by looking at all the
definitions and the details of how we
compute this maximum and minimum and we
have the flexibility now to move our
headers in some other file because we
really want to keep the main function or
the main file here really clean we don't
want all those definitions to show up
here because it is possible for your
project to contain hundreds or even
thousands of definitions if you make all
those declarations show up in the main
cpp file here that's going to be really
hard to follow and work with now we have
the flexibility to split those guys
across multiple files and we can even
use lots of headers if that is what is
going to work for our project this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this one in
the next one we're going to see how we
can pass parameters to functions by
value go ahead and finish up here and
meet me there
in this lecture we're going to see what
is meant by passing parameters to a
function by value and we're going to
look at an example of that here we have
a simple function called say age it's
going to take one parameter which is an
integer called age and in the body of
the function we are printing out the age
after incrementing it suppose this is
something useful
for your program the function is split
into declaration and definition we have
a declaration on top here and we have
our definition below the main function
in the main function we will attempt to
use this function we're going to call it
down here and we're going to pass a
local variable which is called age as
our age when we do that we expect this
to print you are 24 years old because
we're going to increment the age and
we're going to say hello you are 24
years old this is what this program is
going to do but we want to keep track
of how the outside variable here is
going to change and the age we have
passed as a parameter here because this
edge we pass as a parameter is not going
to be the same as the age we have on top
here what we pass here as a parameter is
going to be a copy of the actual
variable that we passed here and this
mechanism is called passing a parameter
by value and what you really pass is
going to be copy and what you work on
inside the body of the function is not
going to be the original stuff you
passed as an argument to the function so
we're going to try and prove that here
we're going to print the age before we
call the function we're going to print
the age after we call the function and
what we print here is going to be the
outside variable because here we are in
the scope
of the main function
inside the say edge function what we're
going to be modifying is a locker copy
so we expect the edge here to stay the
same before and after the function call
so the way this is going to work when
control has this function here it's like
we're going to have a situation like we
have here on the left we're going to set
up local copies in the function that are
going to contain whatever was passed as
an argument to this function and this
edge here was passed as an argument to a
function so we're going to have a local
copy of this h and we're going to store
it and it is what we're going to be
manipulating in our program when the
function goes out of scope the local
copy is going to die and the outside
variable we have here is basically going
to be unaffected let's head over to
visual studio code and show you this in
action
okay here we are in our working folder
the current project is passed by value
we're going to grab our template files
and we're going to put them in place in
the correct project and we're going to
open this up in visual studio code let's
do that we're going to open the folder
that contains the project pass by value
let's do that we are going to open it up
and i'm going to go in the file and
clean it up a little bit and we are
going to set up a function it's going to
not return anything
and it's going to say age
and it's going to take an integer which
is going to be our age
and inside we're going to increment our
h i think this is what we saw in the
slides and we're going to say however
many years you are old we're going to
say hello
you are
age old and we can set up a variable and
the main function we're going to call it
h
and it is going to contain 23 as our age
we're going to say age and we're going
to pass in our age here we can do that
if we're trying to run this program
let's try to do that we're going to
build with gcc and we are going to bring
in a terminal we can use to run this
program easily from
visual studio code here let's run
booster we're going to say hello you are
24 years old and this is what we expect
because when this function is called
we're going to increment the age then
we're going to say the age but we want
to see
what happens to the outside edge ear
if we modify the inside edge that we
have on this function here that was
passed as an argument and again what you
pass when you are declaring your
function is the parameter and what you
pass when you are calling the function
is called an argument in c plus plus
please remember this okay what we pass
as an argument is our anti-age variable
which is local to the main function
and we're going to see what happens to
it let's print the age
and say age before call
i think this is descriptive enough and
we're going to print that and we're
going to go after the function is called
we're going to say the same thing but
we're going to say after call
and
by after we mean after we call the
function say h here i think this is
descriptive enough and we're going to
see that if incrementing the local
variable to the function here affects
the variable that we have and the scope
of the main function okay so let's see
that we're going to build with gcc as
always
and the wealth is good so let's clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
before the call we have 23 and after the
call we have 23 we didn't change the
second call
this is a classical copy paste error
we're going to change that
for our program to really be descriptive
enough
okay the world is good we can clear and
run rooster and now we have before call
23 after call age is 23 it wasn't
changed by what we have inside here and
we can even go further and look at the
memory addresses of these guys
here we can try and print the address of
the age variable let's let's do that
we're going to say
address of age
and put that out here we're going to say
no big deal here we can close the pane
on the left here because it is taking up
valuable space and we're going to go to
the second statement and put in the
address of age
and we're going to print that out we can
do that now we know
the address of operator
okay we can do that
and when we hit the body of our function
here we can also print the address of
age
no big deal
so we can say
address of age let's do that here and
we're going to print the address of the
local edge variable here which was
passed as a parameter here okay now we
can build our program and watch those
addresses we're going to build with gcc
the world is good we can clear
and run a rooster
now you see that the outside variable is
going to leave at an address that ends
in dec
and the local variable is going to leave
at an address that ends in dc0 so this
is a completely new memory location that
we are using and it is just going to
contain a copy of what we passed as a
parameter here and the compiler is going
to take care of setting up this copy
variable and have it available for use
in the local function here we don't have
to worry about that but we have to be
aware that what we are working on and
the same age function here is a copy
it's not the original value this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture making you aware of the call by
value mechanism and the main message is
that what you are working on in the body
of your function when it is called is
going to be a copy of what you have
passed as an argument when your function
was called here
in this lecture we're going to see how
we can pass parameters to functions by
pointer this is going to allow us to
avoid the copies that we were
experiencing when we were passing
parameters by value like we have seen in
the last few lectures here is a simple
example showing the syntax we can use to
pass parameters by pointer
on top here we have our function
declaration and down here we have our
function definition and you see that the
syntax is the same we are passing by
pointer and by pointer and the
definition here and another thing you
should be careful about is that when you
call a function that passes by pointer
you have to give it an address and
that's what we are doing here so we are
passing the address of our age variable
which is going to be passed by pointer
when we pass by pointer we want to be
modifying a copy inside the body of our
function if you look here we are
incrementing the edge variable but we
are doing this through the referencing
so when we pass a pointer here the
pointer is going to contain the address
of this guy
and in the body of the function the
pointer we will have this edge pointer
is going to be pointing to the original
variable here okay so this edge pointer
edge variable
when we dereference it and modify the
variable we're going to be affecting the
original variable i really hope this
makes sense and this is really what
passing by pointer is all about you
declare your functions by passing in
pointers like this and in the definition
you do the same and when you call the
function you need to pass in an address
of the variable because that's what we
store in a pointer here and this is
going to work if we try to run this
example here we're going to print 23
because that's the original value we are
going to call the say age we are going
to increment and this is going to change
the original value if we print here
we're going to get 24 and when this
function terminates we're going to hit
this statement here and we're going to
print 24 this is what we're going to see
when we get to run this program here and
this is really all there is about
passing by pointer we are going to head
over to visual studio code and play with
us a little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
passed by pointer we are going to grab
our template files here
and we're going to put them in the
current project which is pass by pointer
we are going to open this in visual
studio code pretty quick we're going to
choose that pass by pointer we open this
and our main cpp file should show up
here
we're going to clean it up a little bit
we are actually going to grab the code
from the last lecture and put that in
here and that's going to be our starting
point let's close the left pane here so
that we have some breathing space the
function here say h is going to pass by
pointer so we should take out this cost
here
and uh have a pointer here like we had
in the slides we're going to do the same
in our
definition here if we go down we're
going to do that we're going to pass by
pointer and we are going to uncomment
the line that increments our age here
okay after we do that you see that we
have a squiggly line at this line that
calls the say age function what we need
to do is to pass it the address of the
edge variable here like we saw in the
slide so this is the syntax we have to
follow
once we do this this program is going to
be valid and if we run it here we're
going to print 23 because that's the
value we have in here we're going to
call the say age function we are going
to increment age and here we forgot to
do our dereferencing so what we need to
do here is to dereference the age and
increment it this is going to increment
the original variable here and we're
going to be accessing this through the
the referencing operator of our pointer
here if we hit this line and the
function here we're going to print 24
because the value has been
incremented through this statement here
and after the function call we're going
to hit this statement here on line 10
and it is going to print 24. this is
what we expect
take a moment to make sure you really
understand this the things you need to
be careful about is the syntax we use to
declare the function here we say that we
are passing by pointer because of this
little star here and we have the same
thing when we hit the definition of the
function we have this little star so we
are passing by pointer another thing you
should remember is to pass the address
of a variable when you call the function
like we do here and please remember to
use the the reference operator whenever
you want to modify whatever variable is
leaving at the address that you passed
in here so that's why we are the
reference in here through the star
operator like we are doing here this is
really all you need to be careful about
so we are going to try and run this
program let's do that we're going to
build with gcc
the boiler is going to go through we
need to bring in a terminal
so that we can run this program and
again we expect to see a 23 24 and 24
here print it out
so let's run rooster
okay here is our output before we call
the say age function the age is 23 the
address is dec when we hit the function
we are saying hello you are
uh years old so here we should have the
reference to access something inside the
variable here so we should say you are
age old we need to dereference this guy
because now it is a pointer i forgot
that i really am sorry but we are
learning so
this is a good learning chance for you
not to make the same mistake as i am
making here so let's try and build again
we should see the correct output we are
going to clear
and run rooster now we see that before
the call
ages 23 when we call the function h
becomes 24 because we just incremented
through our reference operator and after
the function call the edge is going to
be 24
because we have modified the original
variable here through our the
referencing of the pointer here this is
really all there is about passing by
pointer this is the syntax you have to
pass a pointer in the declaration you
have to pass a pointer in the function
definition and when you call the
function you have to use the address of
the variable and pass that as an
argument to the function and whenever
you need to use the past parameter
you're going to go through the the
reference operator like we did here
and here in the body of our function
here
in this lecture we're going to see how
we can pass parameters to a function by
reference
and this is another technique we can use
to avoid passing by value which is going
to create a copy and the syntax is
really simple if you look at the
declaration here you're going to see
that we say and reference and again if
we hit the definition we're going to say
into reference as you see here
when we call the function we don't have
to pass the address of operator we just
passed the variable because this is
going to be treated as a reference by
the compiler and in the body of the
function we don't have to go through
ugly the referencing like we did with
pointers and hopefully you can see that
if you want to avoid copies passing by
references is much cleaner you don't
have to use the address of operator when
you call the function like we do here
and you don't have to go through the
reference and to access and modify your
variables and the modification we do
here by incrementing age is going to be
seen on the outside because we are going
through a reference and the reference is
a true alliance to the variable that the
reference is referencing so by
incrementing the edge here and the body
of the function the change is going to
be seen after the function call before
the function here we're going to get 23
in the body of the function we're going
to get 24 because we just incremented
the function and after the function call
we're going to get a 24 because the
change was propagated to the original
variable and the reason is because we
are going through a reference here
let's head to visual studio code and
actually play with us a little more okay
here we are in visual studio code the
current project is passed by reference
1710 here so we're going to grab our
template files and put them in place
let's do that and we are going to open
this in visual studio code pretty quick
let's do that the main cpp file is going
to show up here again we are going to
grab the code from the last lecture and
use that as a starting point and we're
going to be modifying the signature of
our function here so what we want to do
is to pass by reference we're going to
say enter reference here you already
know references from a previous chapter
and we are going to hit the definition
here and do the same thing so let's say
and reference
age
and when we call the function we don't
need to pass the address of operator
because this is a reference we can use
it right away the compiler is going to
know that this is going to be a
reference to the original variable that
we passed here
and in the body of the function let's
take out this last line here we don't
need it and in the body when we want to
modify
the reference we can do that right away
without the referencing so we can just
say plus plus h here and the changes are
going to be propagated to the original
variable here because we are going
through a reference let's go down and
modify this because this is a reference
we can use it right away
and we can close this left pane here so
that we have some more breathing space
and you see that visual studio code is
no longer giving us any squiggly lines
so this must be valid c plus plus code
again notice the syntaxes we are using
here we are passing a reference in our
declaration we are passing a reference
in our function definition here when we
call the function we don't need to do
any address of operator we pass the
variable as is
and in the body of the function we don't
have to do any dereferencing we can
increment right away
or modify the variable however we want
the changes are going to be propagated
to the original variable because we are
passing a reference so the
incrementation here is also going to
affect the original variable that was
declared in the main function here let's
take this out and down here if we need
to use our variable we're going to just
use it right away we don't need any
referencing and if we print the address
of age here we're going to see the same
address we see on the outside because
this is a true alias it's going to be
referencing the same variable that we
have in main here okay now that you have
a better idea about this we are going to
try and build this we're going to use
gcc as always you can see that the build
is good
if we bring up a terminal to try and run
this program
we can clear and run rooster
we're going to see that before we call
the function the h is 23 but the address
ends in dec
when we hit the function the edge is 24
because we just incremented that here
but notice that the address of the
variable is the same as on the outside
so we are modifying the same variable
and when the function is done the edge
is still going to be 24 because we just
modified the original variable through a
reference here okay this is the effect
of passing by reference you can use a
claim syntax to modify the original
variable in your functions and this is
going to avoid copies like we have seen
when we were passing parameters by value
a few lectures back i would like to
welcome you in this new chapter where we
will be focusing on how to get data out
of functions again the model of the
function is really what you see here it
is like a machine and you can give input
to that machine and you expect to get
something out of that machine this
chapter is going to focus on this part
here
and we're going to see the different
facilities offered by the c plus plus
programming language to get output from
functions and we are going to start in
the next lecture and see how we can use
input and output parameters go ahead and
finish up here and meet me there in this
lecture we're going to see how we can
use function parameters to get data out
of the function
here is a simple example and we have
three functions here we have max str
max and and max double and you notice
that we have three parameters for each
of these functions the first two
parameters are going to be input they
are going to get data and the function
and the third one is going to be the
output parameter and it is going to get
data out of the function
let's focus on max hdr here and really
drive the point home the key idea here
is that for the third parameter
we are using a modifiable reference and
if we use a reference the changes we do
inside the function are also going to be
visible on the outside and we explicitly
left out the const that we have on the
other parameters because we want to be
able to modify
the output variable here inside the
function if we marked the third
parameter as const we would get a
compiler error if we're trying to do
something like this and assign something
to the output parameter here so the main
purpose of this function is to compute
the maximum between these two strings we
are going to say if input 1 is greater
than input 2
then input 1 is going to be our maximum
and we are going to store that in our
output parameter here if input 1 is not
greater than input 2 then input 2 is our
maximum we're going to store that in our
output and whoever has access to input 2
outside the function is going to see the
changes that we are making in the body
of the function this is really the
technique we can use
to
send output from the function and make
it visible
when the function has returned and again
the key idea is that we set up the
function in a way that the changes we do
inside the function are going to be
visible on the outside and we are able
to do that because output here is a
reference this is really key we have
used references here but we can set up
the same thing using pointers because we
have seen that with pointers we can also
make our changes inside the function
visible to the outside the two other
examples here are really extensions of
the same thing we have two input
variables input 1 and input 2
and
output is going to store the output from
the function you notice that output is a
reference and because of this the
changes we do in here are going to be
visible when this function has returned
and we do exactly the same thing on max
double here
but you see that it is using a pointer
okay i really wanted you to see this so
inside we're going to try and figure out
who is the maximum and if input 1 is the
maximum we're going to write that in our
output variable here and you notice that
we are the referencing here because this
guy is a pointer and if input 2 is our
maximum we're going to write that in our
output variable here one thing i don't
think i explained here is that we have a
cost std string reference here for maxed
hdr and the reason is that the input
variables aren't really meant to be
changed that's why we market them as
cost and if you want to modify them in
some way you can take the const away and
it is going to work okay this is really
the big idea we are playing with in this
lecture using function parameters as a
way to output data from the function and
here are a few ideas you should keep in
mind output parameters should be passed
in such a way that you can modify the
arguments from the inside the functions
and we have seen that we have two ways
to do that we could either use
references or even use pointers but
references are what you should prefer in
modern c plus plus input parameters
shouldn't be modified they are meant to
just get data in the function and that's
why in most cases you're going to see
that they are marked const okay now that
we have seen all these ideas i think it
is time we headed over to visual studio
code and actually played with them okay
here we are in our working folder the
current project is input and output
parameters we are going to grab our
template files like we always do we're
going to put them in place and we are
going to open this guy in visual studio
code we're going to just drag it and
drop on top of visual studio code here
and it is going to open up we have our
main function here we can close the pane
here and clean the file up a little bit
we're going to remove what we don't need
here and we're going to have a bare main
function we can play with here the first
thing we're going to do is to put in our
max str function it is nothing special
we just have two input parameters and
one output parameter the output
parameter is going to be what we use to
get output outside the function and
inside we're just going to compute the
maximum if input 1 is the maximum we're
going to write that in our output
parameter if input 2 happens to be our
maximum we're going to write that in our
output parameter because our output
parameter is a reference the changes we
make inside the function are going to be
visible on the outside because we will
be working on the original variable
through the reference which is really a
true alias here okay now that we have
the function set up like this we can
head in the main function and try it out
we're going to set up three variables of
type std strand i think we should
include the string library here let's do
that and we're going to have an out
string which is going to be our output
variable and we have two input strings
one is initialized with alabama the
other is initialized with bell view and
we're going to call our max sdr function
here you notice that it's not going to
be using the return mechanism we're
going to be grabbing the output from
this function using an output parameter
which is going to be our out hdr
variable here okay once the function is
done we're going to have the maximum
stored in our out sdr variable here and
we can print it out now that we have
this setup we can actually try and build
this we're going to use gcc let's do
that the build is good we can bring up a
terminal and clear and run rooster now
you see that the maximum is going to be
bell view let's try and change this to
casablanca why not and we're going to
see that the maximum now is going to be
casablanca and our function is going to
be smart enough to store the maximum in
this output variable here let's build
again the world is going to be good
going to clear and run rooster now the
maximum is casablanca hopefully you
understand that we are able to make the
changes in the function processed
because our output parameter here is
passed by reference this is a true
reference and any change we do to the
output parameter here is going to be
visible in whatever variable you passed
as an argument for this third argument
here this is what is making this work
now that this is working we're going to
comment this out
and
put in another example for you to play
with the next function we're going to
play with is going to be max and as you
see here and it is very similar to our
max hdr but you notice that our inputs
are no longer references because we
don't really mind copying fundamental
types in c plus plus they are small in
memory so copying them is really cheap
we can pass them by value and this is
not going to be so wasteful in our
program but the first parameter must be
passed by reference because we want to
use it as an output parameter and we're
going to use it to get output from the
function and the way we're going to do
that we're going to write whatever
variable is the maximum in our output
parameter and the changes are going to
be visible on the outside now we are
going to head over in our main function
set up a few variables and play with us
so we're going to say and out and this
is going to be our output variable and
we're going to say input one let's say
in one and we're going to initialize
this with a 45 why not and we're going
to say ent in two and we're going to
initialize this with 23 why not now that
we have this we're going to say max and
and we're going to put in our input
we're going to say n1 and n2 then we're
going to say out and as our output
variable now that we have this we can
actually print out whatever number is
the maximum through an output statement
like this really simple we're going to
say max and and we're going to say out
to end that's where it is going to be
stored and we are able to do this
because again the third parameter here
is passed by reference and any change we
do and the function here is going to
stack even when the function here has
returned and we're going to have that
stored in our third parameter here and
this is a really common technique
especially in code that has to interface
with c code out there from c plus plus
and you really need to be aware of this
now if we run this program we're going
to see our maximum printed out and it is
going to be stored in our out variable
here let's do that we're going to use
gcc to world the world is good you can
clear and run rooster and you're going
to see that the maximum is 45 if we
change and store our maximum in into
here and for example let's make this a
let's build it in to take the changes
into account in our
rooster.xe binary we're going to clear
and run rooster and you're going to see
that that's the maximum here we are able
to grab whatever is the maximum from
these two input parameters and store
that in our output parameter here
because we are passing that third guy as
a reference this is really important we
have seen that we can use references to
make changes we do in the function stick
and be visible in outside variables but
we can also use pointers and i am going
to show you an example of how we can do
that first we're going to comment this
out because we don't want noise output
in our program and we are going to go on
top and set up a max double function
which is going to grab our output using
pointers the name of the function is max
double it's not going to return anything
and it is going to take two input
parameters input 1 and input 2 and it is
going to tell us whichever of these 2 is
the maximum the maximum is going to be
stored in our output parameter but we
are using pointers to make these changes
inside the body of the function stick
and be visible on the outside of the
function so we are going to the
reference here because the third guy
here is a pointer and we're going to
store in whichever is the maximum and
when the function returns the maximum is
going to be visible on the outside so
let's go down and try this out we're
going to say double out double and we're
going to
set up our input here we're going to say
in double one and we're going to make
this
45.8 why not and we're going to do a
second input parameter and int we should
say n not end sorry for this in double
for input double so we're going to say
double 2 and we're going to initialize
this with 6.9
for example we can really put in
anything now that we have this we can
call our max double function let's do
that going to say max double we're going
to say in double one and in double two
let's do that and we're going to have
out double as our output parameter and
uh because it's a pointer we need to
pass this guy as an address so we're
going to say address of how to double
here that's how we're going to be able
to manipulate that inside the function
here once we do this we are going to
have our maximum stored and out double
and we can print that out so we're going
to say stdcl max double and we're going
to say mac and we're going to say out to
double std e and el and if we weld why
do we have a squiggly line here we don't
have a semicolon at the end of our
function called here so we're going to
build with gcc as always you're going to
see that the world is good we can clear
and run rooster max is 45.8
if we change and store our maximum and
in double to here we can change this guy
to 76.9
we're going to build and see that we are
actually grabbing the maximum regardless
of the variable in which it is stored if
we run rooster we're going to have our
maximum and this is working exactly as
we want this is really all we set out to
do in this lecture showing you how you
can use references to use parameters as
output channels for data to get outside
of the function and be used in variables
that are outside the function here i
really hope this makes sense and this is
a technique you need to be aware of
we're going to see other techniques to
do the same thing and uh starting in the
next lecture we're going to see how we
can return from functions for now i hope
you found this lecture interesting we
are going to stop here in this one in
the next one we're going to see how we
can use the return mechanism to get data
outside our function go ahead and finish
up here and make me there
in this lecture we're going to see how
we can get data outside of a function
through the return mechanism and this is
going to be an alternative to the way we
have been doing things in the last
lecture where we used function
parameters as channels to get data
outside the function
let's look at the simple example of how
this is done here we have a simple
function called sum the function is
going to return end
and it is going to sum up two parameters
that we pass to at nta and end b
if we get inside the function we're
going to do something really simple
we're going to set up a new variable
which is local to the function we're
going to call that reserved it's going
to be the same type as our input
parameters and we're going to add up a
and b and store the results back in our
result variable here
once we have this we're going to return
this for this variable to be visible by
whoever called this function here one
thing you should know is that this
variable is local to this function here
and it will be destroyed the moment we
hit the end of the function here and the
function terminates
so if we go in main here we're going to
try and see an example of how we can
call this function we have two variables
a and b and we have a new result
variable set up in the main function
please note that this variable is very
different from the variable we have and
the
sum function here because they live in
different scopes okay we are calling our
sum function here and we are passing it
two arguments in the form of a and b
here the function is going to compute
our sum and it's going to return it and
we're going to store that back in our
local variable to the main function here
the result variable here again is local
to this main function okay once we call
this function we're going to have our
results stored in here and if we print
like we do here we're going to see it
printed out on the console in this case
it's going to print 50 because 34 adding
16 that's going to be 50. but one thing
i want you to know is that this is going
to return by value and what we mean by
this is that we're going to copy
whatever we return here and store a copy
of that in this result variable that we
have in the main function and we're
going to prove this
notice the stdc out statement we have
here this is going to print the address
of this local variable and once the
function terminates we're going to try
and print the address of this resort
variable in the local scope of the main
function and we're going to see two
different addresses and hopefully this
is going to prove that we are returning
a copy it's not the original variable
that we have in the sum function here
that we are returning okay hopefully
this drives the point home that we can
use the return mechanism to get data
outside the function and we're going to
grab the result in our result variable
here and we're going to use it however
we wanted the main function
but things don't always work like this
sometimes the compiler is going to
insert optimizations
and not really returned by value but
returning by value is the default but if
the compiler notices that it can do
things better it is going to optimize
your returns by value to return by
reference and you're not going to make a
copy but you're going to somehow reuse
the local variable in the main function
let's look at a simple example to really
drive this home we have a function here
which is going to add strength it is
going to basically concatenate them
using the plus operator here and you
notice that inside the function here
we're going to set up a local variable
which is going to store our concatenated
string here
and we're going to print the address of
the local string after that we're going
to return the strength so that it is
usable by whoever calls this function
let's go in main and see how we can use
this function here we are setting up a
variable called sdr result which is
going to store our result strength we
are saying add strings here we are
calling our function and we are passing
in two strings hello and world and we
want to concatenate these guys this is
going to give us our result and if we
print it out we're going to get hello
world printed out but the main message
here is that the address of the outside
string here is going to be the same as
the address we have on the inside here
and this is going to mean that the
compiler has actually
done some magic
to return the local variable because it
has seen that we could really be wasting
this guy here inside the function when
the function returns this string result
here is going to die off but the
compiler knows that we can reuse that
and avoid the work of copying this
string which might be really large
suppose this string has a thousand
characters inside and copying it would
be a waste so the compiler is not going
to return by value which is the default
it is going to do some kind of return by
reference but it's really not a return
by reference because this is a local
variable we can't really have a
reference to a local variable to a
function that would be really bad
because we might be able to modify it
when the variable is actually dead after
the function has returned so it is a
magic that the compiler is doing to save
you from unnecessary copies but you
should be aware of this and not make
your code rely on returning by value
okay now that we know this we're going
to head over to visual studio code and
actually play with us here we are in our
working folder the current project is
returning from functions by value we're
going to grab our template files pretty
quick we're going to copy them let's do
that and we're going to put them in the
current lecture or project
and we're going to open this guy up in
visual studio code pretty quick let's do
that
now we have our main cpp file here we
can clean it up a little bit
and close the left pane here because we
don't need it the first thing we're
going to do is to put in our function
which is going to compute the sum of two
integers and return as the sum of these
two guys inside the function we're going
to set up a result variable which is
going to store the sum and we're going
to return it and it is going to be
visible to whoever has called this
function here again i am going to
emphasize that this is going to return
by value so what we return is really
going to be a copy of this variable here
and we're going to prove that by
printing the address of this variable
inside and outside the function here so
we're going to set up two variables in
main we're going to say and x let's call
our input parameters x and y we're going
to put in a five and the second guy is
going to be a y and it's going to store
an n9 why not after that we're going to
set up a variable which is going to
store the results let's call this result
why not and we're going to say some x
and y okay we are passing these guys by
value because we don't really care about
copying and and it is a fundamental type
it is really small in memory so it's
going to be very cheap to copy it's not
going to hurt the performance of our
application but what we want to do now
is to print
the address of the reserved variable in
the main function here and see that it
is the same as the
address of the variable we have inside
here another thing you should watch out
for is that we are able to get data
outside the function here the sum was a
local variable but we are able to get it
out of the function through the return
mechanism here okay before we go ahead
and run this program we're going to fix
the statement here we forgot to change
this to say out to mean that it is
outside the function here that's the
meaning we're going to build with gcc
the world is good we can clear and run
rooster now we're going to see that
inside the function the address of the
result variable here
ends in dac
and outside the function when we hit
the end of the function here we're going
to see that the address ends in de4 so
this proves that the local variable
inside the function and the outside
variable here in the main function
leaving two different memory addresses
there are two different variables and
the return mechanism here is just going
to copy whatever we have in the local
variable and make it available on the
outside here so that we can assign it to
the reserved variable in our main
function here this is how the return
mechanism is working and it is going to
be returning by value by default it is
going to be making copies this is the
message here now that we know this i
want to show you that there are
exceptions to that rule
if you return by value like this you
won't be really always using separate
memory addresses for the inside and the
outside here and we're going to prove
that with a function that is going to
add up two strings
let's comment what we have out because
we don't want this to confuse us so
we're going to bring this inside our
block comment here and we are going to
go below our sum function here and set
up a new function which is going to be
called add strands it is going to return
a string by value okay it is by value
because this return type here is not
qualified with anything like a pointer
or a reference so by default it is going
to be by value and inside you see we are
doing the exact same thing we did in the
sum function here we are adding up two
strands we are storing the results in a
local variable and we are returning that
but if we run this program you're going
to see that the address on the inside is
going to be the same as the address on
the outside so let's set up something
that we can play with here we're going
to go down in the main function and set
up a few variables we're going to say
hdd strand we're going to say
nstr1 and we're going to store in hello
let's do that and we're going to say std
strength
and str2
and we're going to store and world by
now you know what i am trying to do here
i am trying to say hello world okay once
we have this we're going to set up a
resort strike so we're going to say std
strength and i say result str and we're
going to say add sdr and we're going to
add up
nstr1 and in str2 this is how we do this
and after we do this we're going to
print out the address of the variable
here so let's do that and it is going to
be the address of result hdr let's say
that here and we also need to print the
actual result of this operation here so
let's do that we're going to say sddc
out result sdr we're going to print the
actual
strength i don't think we did that on
our
sum function here but we can quickly go
there and prove that to you so let's
comment this out sorry for this this is
going to be confusing but i don't want
to leave you with
unexplained thanks
so we're going to see that if we print
this out we're going to get the sum
which is 14 printed out let's do that
pretty quick we're going to go down and
say sddcl and say result and we're going
to say result and we're going to build
it pretty quick with the gcc and if we
clear and run the rooster we're going to
see the result which is 14 here and you
can change these guys up to really play
with us for example if we make this 15
and put in a 9 we're going to get a 24
printed out let's build again
just to have fun with this and we're
going to clear and run rooster we're
going to get a 24 here now we can
comment this back i am happy i have
showed you this and we can uncomment our
string code here and uh build and run it
so we're going to build with gcc the
build is good we can clear and run
rooster and again what we want to see
is that the compiler is going to
optimize this out it is not going to
return by value like we had was the sum
function where we had the address on the
inside different from the address on the
outside you see here that inside ah we
forgot again to change this guy to out
uh sorry for this so we're going to make
this guy out and we're going to build
again and we're going to clear
clear and run rooster now we're going to
see that inside the address ends in d30
and outside the address ends in d30 this
can be really confusing because we said
we want to return by value by not
decorating our return type with a
pointer or a reference or something like
that it is going to be returning by
value and if you return by value you're
going to make copies and if we made the
copies the address on the inside and the
address on the outside should be
different but they are the same the
reason is the compiler is going to
notice that you are trying to copy
strands
and it is going to see that the variable
here which is inside the function is
going to be wasted when the function
returns
by default this should be really
destroyed and you should copy
because you are returning by value but
the compiler is going to insert an
optimization to do some magic and make
it look like you are returning by
reference and it is really not going to
make a copy so it is going to reuse the
address on the inside and hopefully this
is going to prove this to you the
message here is that you shouldn't rely
on your functions
returning by value because if the
compiler sees that it can do a better
job than you it is going to optimize
your return by value to return by
reference and you're going to not be
making copies so don't make your code
rely on returning by value and making
copies and you should be aware of these
optimizations that the compiler can do
behind your back i would like to welcome
you in this new chapter where we will be
learning about function overloading
function overloading is a mechanism we
have in c plus plus
to have multiple copies of the same
function but taking different parameters
for example here you see that we have
different functions but all these
functions have the same function name
and these are said to be different
overloads of the same function there are
a couple of rules you need to be aware
of to be able to set up your overalls
correctly and get them to work and
that's what we're going to be learning
about in detail in this chapter but now
i just want you to see the flexibility
you can get with function overloading
for example here if we have a few
variables in our program we can call the
max function and the compiler is going
to select the most fitting overloading
here so for example if we call our
function with integer arguments the
compiler is going to choose this
overload here if we call a function with
std string arguments the compiler is
going to choose this overload here and
we don't really need to concern
ourselves
with making sure we have the correct
arguments the compiler is going to
choose the correct function overload for
us and it is going to call it and it's
going to be very flexible to call these
functions from our c plus plus code this
is how function overload can be really
useful we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
learn about how you can set up function
overloads based on different function
parameters
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to see
how we can overload functions based on
the parameters that we pass to the
function when we are declaring it or
defining it and here is a simple example
to drive the point home here we have a
function called max
and this is the name
it is taking two parameters which are of
type and here
and by overloading this function we will
have to use the same name as this
function here so the differences really
will be in the parameters that we pass
to the function because the return type
isn't
involved in defining the signature of
the function so if we try to set up
another function called max here which
takes the exact
same parameters as our max on top here
the difference is only going to be in
the return type the compiler is not
going to allow us to do this because the
return type isn't really significant
in making two functions different okay
the only way we have to set up a
function which is legal in c plus plus
is to change something about the
parameters that we have here we can
change the types like you see here for
example we change the types to b double
if the types are different we might even
change the order of the parameters you
just have to make sure the parameter
list is different in one way or another
that's how you're going to get this
function to run with the same names here
and if we manage to set up multiple
functions with the same name in c plus
plus these functions are going to be
called overloads of each other okay if
we go down here we have another overload
for the max function this overload is
going to take two parameters and the
parameters are going to be of type
string view they are different from what
we have on top here which is ant so this
is a legal overload for this max
function here and we can use it okay we
really have a few ways we can make our
function overloads by now we can change
the order of the parameter we can change
the number of the parameters or even we
can change the types of the parameters
again function overloads are a mechanism
we have in c plus plus to set up
multiple functions with the same name to
make our code easier to work with okay
now that you know that let's look at a
simple example of how we can call our
overloads we have a few variables
declared here we have ant variables we
have double variables and we have std
string view variables
and if you go down here we are calling
our max function passing in integers so
the overload that takes integers for
this max function is going to be called
here down here we are passing in integer
literals so this is going to call the
int overload down here we are calling
the function with double parameters or
arguments so this is going to call our
double overload for the match function
here and down here we are passing in our
string view parameters and this is going
to call the overload that takes string
view parameters and the last guy here is
going to take
two string literals string literals can
implicitly convert to std string view so
our std string view overload for the max
function here is going to be called
now that we know this we're going to
head over to visual studio code and play
with this a little more okay here we are
in our working folder the current
project is overloading with different
parameters here we're going to grab our
template files like we always do we're
going to put them in place
and we are going to open this guy in
visual studio code by dragging and
dropping on top of visual studio code
here this is going to open our project
here we're going to click on our main
cpp file and open it we're going to
clean it up a little bit and close the
left pane here we are going to go on top
here and put in our first max function
here the return type is and in this case
it is going to take two parameters and
it is going to return whichever number
is the maximum and we are taking
parameters in by value and returning by
value here nothing special we can go in
main and call this function and you
already know how to do that i don't
think i really need to do that
but now what we really are interested in
is being able to set up different
functions with the same function name
like we have here because if for example
you take this function and put that down
below we're going to make a copy of it
and only change the return type if we
try to compile this program you see that
even visual studio code is unhappy now
if we bring up a terminal it is going to
tell us cannot overload function
distinguished by the return type alone
so again the message is super clear here
the return type is not enough to make
two functions different because the
return type isn't involved in making the
signature unique what makes the
signature unique is either the function
name or the parameters that you pass to
the function here so we're going to make
this return type back a double and we're
going to figure out a way to make these
two functions different but have the
same name here because sometimes you
really want this
one way we have to do this is to change
the types of the parameters that we pass
in here so we're going to make them
double and we're going to make them
double here and this is going to be
valid c plus plus could these two
functions are different even if they
have the same name here they are two
different functions because they take
different parameters so if you try to
call this function with
integers this one is going to be called
which takes integers n if you call it
with double arguments this guy here is
going to be called let's try and prove
this so we're going to go inside and say
stdc out and overload called i think
this is enough and we're going to go in
the double function here and say sddc
out double overload cool
okay once we have this we also have to
change the return type here to double
because it's going to make things a
little bit consistent here but now we
want to go in our main function here
and set up a few variables we're going
to say and x and we're going to make
this a four and we're going to say into
y and we're going to make this a nine
why not
we're going to set up also double
variables let's say double a
and say five
point four to make it a double variable
and we're going to say double
b and put in 7.4
why not
now we are going to call max we're going
to say auto result and say max and
passing x and y
what do you think we're going to return
here so what we really are interested in
is the return type of the result
variable here and the compiler is going
to deduce whatever is returned by this
function if we call the function with x
and y x and y are integers so the
compiler is going to search for a
function that takes integers and it's
going to find this guy here and that's
what it's going to be called
let's weld and run this program we are
not interested in looking at the output
here we're just going to see this std
out statement here print whatever
function was called okay we expect the
end one to be called so we're going to
see ant overload called on the terminal
here when we run this program so let's
do that we're going to build with gcc
like we always do the world is good so
we can clear and run rooster
we're going to see int overload called
okay so this proves that
we can set up two functions with the
same name and make them different only
in the parameters that they take and the
differences may be either in the types
of the parameter like we are doing here
they may also be in the order of the
parameters and we're going to see an
example of that in a minute but before
we do that we also need to try this with
a and b and show you that the double one
is going to be called because we are
passing in double arguments here so
let's build again the bullet is good we
can clear and run rooster this is going
to call our double overload hopefully
this really drives the point home
that we can set up multiple overloads
for the same function name and again the
differences are going to be in the
parameters that we pass here we have
been able to pass different types for
the parameters and this was a vehicle c
plus plus code but we can also set up
another overload just by changing the
types and the order of the parameters
let's do that we're going to make the
first parameter here and and once we do
that this is different from any of the
overloads we've had so this is a valid
overload for this max function here this
is going to work we can even change the
order of these two guys and it is also
going to be
a valid overload let's put in another
variant of this guy
and we're going to change the first
parameter to double and the second one
to end and now we have four overloads
for the max function and again the
message here is that you just have to
make sure the parameters are different
in some way and your overload is going
to be valid and again i'm not telling
you to set up functions like this
because in this case this is really
useless but i am trying to expose this
facility to you so that you can use it
to your advantage if it makes sense for
whatever application you are designing
here so let's go down and put in
meaningful output i think we can come in
here and say the parameters that we are
passing in here so we can say and double
overload called and if we go down here
you can take this out and say double and
overload called and to get any of these
guys to be called we have to pass the
parameters or of the arguments in this
order
so if we pass in an end which is x x is
in it and we pass in a double which is a
b here this is going to call our
overload which takes the first argument
to be an integer and the second argument
to be double
let's prove that we're going to
build with the gcc the bolt is good so
we can clear and we can run rooster and
we see ant double called because x is an
end
and b is a double if we flip these guys
let's say b and x then we're going to
have the overload that takes the first
argument of double type and the second
argument of into type to be called and
that's this guy here and we're going to
see this message printed out on the
terminal here let's build with gcc to
really prove this so we're going to do
that
the bullet is good we can clear and run
rooster
and the double end overload called
hopefully you can really see that you
can set up all kinds of crazy overloads
for your functions the next thing i want
you to see is that we can even change
the number of the parameters for example
here we can set up another guy here and
i call it max it is going to be exactly
like the one on top here for the first
two parameters but let's add a third
parameter maybe make it an end and say c
and this is going to be
a valid overload for the max function
here so we're going to say double and
because it takes
three parameters i won't go into the
details of how we can compute the
maximum between these three guys what i
really am interested in is showing you
that you can set up overloads here so
for this case we are just going to
return let's just say a this is going to
work but this is a valid overload for
the match function and it is going to
compile so let's draw and do that we're
going to pass and a double a net and the
net so we're going to pass in b which is
a double and x and y
let's see what is called here we can
compile with gcc the border is good we
can clear and please
try to come up with what is going to be
printed out here what is going to be
printed okay now that you have guessed
we're going to run and we're going to
see double and ant because this is going
to call this overload again you can
overload based on the differences in the
types of the parameters that you pass
you can change the order of the
parameters like we are doing here double
end and end double or you can even
change the number of the parameters
using these techniques you can make sure
that your overloads are different in
some way
before i close this lecture i'm going to
show you that you can also use another
overload that takes
string view parameters let's go down
here and put that in
again the name of the function is max
the return type isn't really meaningful
in making sure two functions are
different but watch the parameters we
pass here the types are string view
and we have a and b here and we are
going to compute the maximum so if we go
down here and say max and pass n hello
and world the compiler is going to try
and look for a function that takes two
character array parameters it's not
going to find it because we don't have
that guy in here but it's going to see
which function can
take something i can come up with
through implicit conversions and the
compiler is going to see that it can
really convert from
a string literal to a string view type
and it is going to insert an implicit
conversion from
string literal to string view and this
function here is going to be called so
we're going to put in a an output
statement here we're going to say
string view string view overload called
and if we try and run this program let's
build with gcc make sure that the build
is good
the world is good so we can clear and
run rooster this is going to show string
view string view overload called we are
able to call this guy here and again the
message is that we really have a lot of
flexibility in how we can set up
overloads for a function in c plus plus
and please use this facility at your
advantage if this makes things better
for whatever application you are
designing i would like to welcome you in
this new chapter where we're going to be
learning about lambda functions lambda
functions are a mechanism we have in c
plus plus to set up anonymous functions
once we have anonymous function set up
we can do all kinds of crazy things with
them for example we can give them names
and code them multiple times or we can
even call them directly without even
giving them a name i realize this can be
really cryptic so we're going to head
over to the next lecture and see how we
can declare and use our lambda functions
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to see how we can declare and use
our lambda functions and again lambda
functions are a mechanism we have in c
plus plus to set up anonymous functions
and an anonymous function is a function
without a name we're going to see how we
can set up an anonymous function
optionally give it a name and call it or
we can even call it directly without
giving that a name let's see how we can
do that before we talk about anything
about lambda functions we're going to
first to see
the lambda function signature and there
is a special syntax you have to follow
if you want to set up a lambda function
in c plus plus the first thing you have
to put in place is angle brackets like
this and that's going to be your capture
list we are not going to talk anymore
about this we're going to have a chance
to talk about this in detail after your
capture list which is going to leave in
this pair of angle brackets you're going
to have the parameters to your lambda
functions and this is where you can pass
arguments if you want to call your
lambda function after that you're going
to have a return type for your lambda
function but you don't have to put this
in explicitly you can live this out and
the compiler is going to deduce your
return type by itself
after all these things you have to put
in a pair of curly braces and inside
these curly braces we're going to have
our function body and we can do whatever
we want our lambda function to do in
this function body here after this you
will have to remember to put your
semicolon to make whatever statements
contain
this along the function to be valid and
this is the syntax you have to follow
here we have a simple example so we have
our lambda function we want to say hello
to the console this is what we have in
the body of the lambda function but
notice that we have our capture list
which is going to be
delimited by these angle brackets we
have our parameter list which is going
to be empty in this moment because this
lambda function doesn't take any
parameter and we have our body which is
going to leave within
these two curly braces and after that we
have our semicolon to make this a valid
c plus plus statement if we try and put
this thing in our c plus plus source
code
this is going to be a valid lambda
function but it isn't really useful by
now because we can't call it one way we
have to call it is to give it a name and
we can give it a name by assigning our
lambda function to a variable like we
see here once we have our lambda
function declared like this this entire
thing is going to be our lambda function
type we can take this and assign that to
a variable which is going to deduce the
type
using auto type deduction here this is
what we are doing
once this thing has a name then we can
call it with the syntax we have here and
if we run this code now it is going to
print hello world to the console i
realize this syntax can be really
cryptic but if you try to remember this
you're going to find that lambda
functions are really cool and later in
the course we will see that they really
make a lot of things easier in c plus
plus so try to remember the syntax here
and everything is going to flow from
here again the syntax is to have the
capture list which is going to be the
first thing the second thing is going to
be the parameters the third thing is
going to be the return type which is
optional you can leave this out and the
compiler is going to deduce this and
after this you're going to have your
pair of curly braces and the body of our
lambda function is going to leave within
these curly braces this is the syntax
you need to remember okay we have seen
that we can give a name to our lambda
function and call it but it is also
possible to call our lambda function
directly without giving it a name and we
do that by appending a pair of curly
braces to the lambda function definition
here so we have a lambda function we
have our curly braces and we have our
parameter list we have our body here and
after the closing curly brace we're
going to add a pair of parentheses to
call this lambda function and because
this lambda function takes no parameter
we're not going to put any argument
within our parenthesis here and this is
going to call our lambda function don't
worry if you find this confusing we're
going to head over to visual studio code
in a minute and all of this is going to
make sense okay so far we haven't really
seen that we can pass parameters to our
lambda function here is a simple example
that takes parameters this is a lambda
function because it follows the syntax
for lambda functions we have
our capture list we have our parameter
list we have our curly braces and the
body is going to live inside these guys
and we are calling this lambda function
directly with this parameter list the
lambda function is going to take two
parameters of double type we're going to
print out the sum of these two numbers
and that we are going to call this
lambda function directly notice that we
are passing in our arguments
as
double
literals okay this is how you can set up
a lambda function that takes parameters
and call it directly another thing we
can do is make our lambda function
return something and that's really
simple we're going to set up the lambda
function like this so it's going to take
two parameters a and b
and here you see that we are returning a
plus b and we can do that the lambda
function is now going to return
something and this entire thing we have
here is going to be a lambda expression
the lambda function is going to be
called it is going to return something
and what the lambda function returns is
going to be assigned to this result
variable here and if we print it we're
going to get the sum of whatever pass in
here printed out on the console and
you're going to see it printed out on
the terminal it is also possible to put
your lambda function directly in an
output statement i realize this can be
really confusing but please look at this
entire lambda function is same here
as a single value because this is a
lambda function that is going to return
something and what is returned by this
lambda function is going to be printed
as our result here
again i realize this may be confusing to
many of you guys we are going to head
over to visual studio code in a minute
and we're going to see this and you're
going to really understand okay the last
thing we're going to look at is that we
can specify a return type to our lambda
function and the syntax to do this is to
do a dash
a greater than symbol and put your type
after that and when you do that now this
lambda function is going to be forced to
return double type even if you pass it
to parameters that are not of double
type we are going to add them up and the
return type is going to be implicitly
converted to double and that's what
we're going to return and we can print
it out on the console and we're going to
see an example of this in a minute when
we hit visual studio code in fact this
is really all i had to share with you in
the slides i realized many of these
things may be confusing we are going to
head over to visual studio code and play
with these things step by step and i am
sure you're going to understand here we
are in our working directory the current
project is declaring and using lambda
functions we're going to grab our
template files and put them in place
let's do that and we're going to grab
our folder here and drag and drop it in
visual studio code and this is going to
open it it is opened here we have our
main cpp file opened we can close the
left pane here because we don't want it
anymore and we can clean up our function
here and the first thing we're going to
do is to put in the syntax for a lambda
function here and use it as a reference
as we learn about this i think this is
going to make things a little easier so
the first thing we want to do is to
declare a lambda function and the first
thing we need to put in is a capture
list a capture list is going to be in
globe in this angle bracket so this is
our empty capture list and after this
we're going to put in a parameter list
which is going to leave inside this
parenthesis here after that we're going
to put in
an optional return type for now we're
going to ignore this and after that
we're going to put in our pair of curly
braces and inside this pair of curly
braces is where the body of our lambda
function is going to leave so inside
here we can do whatever we want in the
body of this lambda function for example
we can say hello world which is
the logical thing to do at this point so
we're going to say hello world here and
we're going to put in our new line
character with endl okay now we have a
lambda function declared but we have to
put in a closing semicolon because this
is a c plus plus statement okay now we
have our lambda function declared and
this is valid c plus plus code if we're
trying to compile this program you're
going to see that it is going to compile
fine cape world finished successfully
and if we try to run it it is not going
to do a thing because we are declaring
the lambda function here but we're not
calling it to get it to do things
so let's bring up a terminal and show
you that if we run this program it is
not going to do anything so let's do
clear and run rooster you're going to
see that it's not going to print
anything and we can even go down here
and put in a closing stdc out statement
saying it done to me that we are hitting
the end of the function here without
doing anything so if we vote again the
vote is going to be good we can clear
and we're going to run rooster you see
we are printing done we are hitting the
end of the function here and are we not
seeing hello world so this function here
or this lambda function here to be exact
is not being called one way we have to
call it is to give it a name
and we have seen that to give it a name
we have to assign the entire lambda
function thing we have here to a
variable and we're going to use auto
type deduction here so we're going to
say auto func and we're going to assign
our lambda function here to this
variable and this is going to be
basically a handle we have in our
program here to the lambda function and
we can use this handle to do things with
the lambda function but by now i want
you to see that even if we run the
program now it is not going to do
anything because we're still not calling
the lambda function here let's show you
that we're going to world again and the
world is going to be good no problem we
can clear and run rooster still not
hello world because we're not calling
our lambda function to call our lambda
function we have to use our handle here
which is this variable and use regular
function called syntax so we can go down
here and say func and we can put in our
parenthesis we're not putting in any
parameter because this lambda here
doesn't take any parameters and now if
we run this program it is going to say
hello world because this line here is
going to call this lambda function let's
bolt and see that
we're going to use gcc to build
so now if we clear and run rooster we're
going to see hello world we can call
this function multiple times because we
have a handle to it the handle is going
to be valid
throughout the scope of the main
function here so we're going to go down
and call it again and if we build we're
going to build with gcc the world is
good we can clear and run rooster we're
going to say hello world twice because
we are calling our lambda function twice
this is one way we have to call our
lambda function here
so we're going to comment this out
because we're going to see a few other
things and on top here what we were
doing is declaring around the function
and call it through an a now we're going
to go down set up a lambda function and
call it directly without giving it a
name because that's also a possibility
in c plus plus for that we're going to
grab our lambda function here and we're
going to copy it and we're going to say
declare a lambda function and call it
direct and the syntax to do that is
really simple
you set up your lambda function like we
have seen before you see this is our
lambda function statement here but
you're going to go to the closing curly
brace and add a pair
of parentheses this is going to declare
the lambda function and call it directly
notice that we don't have a handle to
this lambda function so if you do things
like this you will have only one chance
to call the lambda function so we're
going to say hello world once because we
are declaring the lambda function and
calling it directly here and after that
we're going to say done because we're
going to be hitting the end of the main
function here
let's build the program and show you
that we're going to build with gcc like
we always do we're going to clear
and run rooster this is going to say
hello world and we're going to be done
here because we are calling this lambda
function once again notice that now we
don't have a handle to this lambda
function so we really have one chance to
call this and you will do this if you
just want to set up some function that
you want to call directly and you don't
care about calling it ever again in your
c plus plus application and we're going
to see that we have many kinds of
problems where we want to do these kinds
of things
okay now that you have seen this the
next thing i want to show you is how to
set up a lambda function that takes
parameters and we're going to comment
out what we have on top here because we
don't want noise output on our terminal
and we're going to grab this lambda
function and adapt it
so let's copy it we're going to go down
here and put it in and we want to pass
two parameters now let's pass in double
parameters we're going to pass in double
a and double d you can do that
and inside the lambda function we can
print the sum of these two variables so
we're going to say a plus b for example
and we're going to print out whatever is
the result of a plus b let's do that and
after we do that you're going to see
that we get a compiler error because now
our lambda function is taking parameters
but we are calling that with an empty
list of parameters
so we need to give it something to sum
up let's give it 10.0 for example and a
5.0 and see what we get and after this
we need to put in our semicolon because
this is a z plus plus statement and any
c plus plus statement needs to end with
a semicolon now try to think about what
we are doing here we are setting up a
lambda function okay it's going to end
at this closing
curly brace and this lambda function is
going to take two parameters of double
type
and inside the lambda function we are
going to print out whatever is the sum
of these two parameters that we are
taking in here
after that we are calling our lambda
function with two variables 10.0 and 5.0
or i should say two double literals
that's what we are calling our lambda
function with and now if the program
runs the lambda function is going to be
called once and we're going to print out
whatever is the sum of these two numbers
and that's going to be 15. let's build
so we're going to build with gcc
the world is good we can clear and run
rooster we're going to see a plus b is
15. we are calling a lambda function
here if we put in a 50 here for example
we're going to get 60 printed out
because that's going to be our sum okay
let's boil it again and see that print
it down if we run rooster we're going to
see 60 because that's the sum of 10 and
50 here
another thing we can do is actually
not call the lambda function directly
here we can actually comment this out i
don't want to take this out because you
might want to use this as a reference so
we're going to comment this out and set
up another example
that is going to name our lambda
function and then we will have a handle
to the lambda function and we can call
it multiple times
so let's take out the call we are doing
here and we're going to assign our
lambda function to a variable we're
going to say auto func one we can call
this func one no problem and now
we can call this lambda function
multiple times for example we can say
funk one and pass in 10 and 20 okay and
we can say funk one and pass in five
and seven why not
if we run this program it is going to
print the sum of 10 and 20 and it is
going to print the sum of five and seven
and it is going to be calling this
lambda function multiple times hopefully
you can see that if you want a chance to
call your lambda function multiple times
you will need to give it a handle like
we are doing here and then you can use
that handle
multiple times and call your lambda
function however many times you want so
let's build this program and see what we
get on the console
i'm going to clear and run rooster
now we're going to see a plus b it's 30
as a result of this call here and we're
going to see a plus b is 12
as a result of this call here notice
that we are passing an integer literals
so the compiler is going to insert an
implicit conversion from and to double
because our lambda function here is
taking double type you really need to be
aware of these implicit conversions and
make sure they are working to your
advantage if they are working against
you trying to find a way to make your
code work exactly like you want because
we are learning about all these cool
tricks in c plus plus you're going to be
using them at your advantage okay
hopefully now you know how you can set
up a lambda function that takes
parameters we're going to go down and
comment this out because now we want to
see how we can return something from a
lambda function and we're going to be
using the same lambda function here so
let's grab it and we're going to say
lambda function that returns something
and we're going to set up our lambda
function here let's put that in place
correctly
and instead of printing out the sum of a
and b
we can return that we can go in our
lambda function and say return
a plus b okay now that we have this we
can either call it directly by saying
for example 10 and 20 but now if we try
and run this code it is not going to do
anything try to guess why
this lambda function is not printing to
the concept directly it is just
returning whatever is the sum of 10 and
20.
and if we return it we're not doing
anything with whatever is returned from
this lambda function so we're not going
to print anything and we're just going
to print done here
let's boil and make you see this because
you really need to be aware of these
little things
so the build is good we can clear and
run rooster we're going to see down our
lambda function is returning something
but we're not doing anything with the
return value
if we want to print the return value we
need to catch it somehow and we can put
that in a variable for example we can
say auto result and assign the return
value of our lambda function to this
variable now we have a chance to print
this for example by doing sddc out
result and we're going to
print that out and save result now if we
build this program it is going to print
whatever is the sum of 10 and 20. let's
do that and show you that this is
actually the case
so world is good so we can clear and run
rooster result is 30. if we pass in 10
and 50 for example we're going to get
the same thing let's pass in 60 here
so we're going to build with gcc the
build is good we can clear pretty quick
and run rooster now the sum is 70 and
this is how you can return stuff from
your lambda function and once you return
stuff you have to be sure you cut your
results and print them out another thing
you can do is print out the result
directly after you call your lambda
function so for example we can grab this
entire lambda function thing here and
put that in an sddc out statement so
we're going to put in a second one here
and say result or we can even comment
this out we don't want to be confused
when we look at the terminology we're
going to comment out the first sddc out
statement here and we're going to say
stdendl here and put in a placeholder
for our lambda function and we're going
to paste it in
if we do something like this again this
entire lambda function thing is going to
return the sum and that's what we're
going to print i realize this syntax is
really cryptic but it is going to work
let's try and build our program here the
world is good so we can clear and run
rooster we're going to see that result
is 70 and this is coming from our call
here which is nested inside our htdc out
statement you can do this if you want
another thing you can do as we have seen
before is give your lambda function a
name and call it repeatedly so for
example we can try and comment out what
we have here and set up another lambda
function because we
don't want to confuse you again so we're
going to grab our lambda function here
we're going to copy it because we don't
want to type this a thousand times
and we don't want to call this lambda
function directly instead we want to
give it a name and we're going to say
aro funk 2 and we're going to assign our
lambda function type to func one
now that we have this we can say auto
result 1 for example
and we can say func and we can pass in
whatever we want let's put in 23 and a
seven
and this is going to add up 23 and seven
we're going to grab the result and we're
going to assign that to result one
if we go down and say auto for example
result two and say for example funk one
and say
9 and 45
why not and go down and print out these
result variables we're going to see the
sums printed out and again the message
is that we can use this handle to call
our lambda function multiple times so
let's go down and print this out we're
going to say
result one and we're going to say result
one here we're going to go down and say
result two and we're going to print that
out and we can even call this lambda
function directly and put that in sddc
out here so let's say that we're going
to say result to 3 for example or direct
call i think this is descriptive enough
so we're going to say func
one the name of our lambda function or
the handle to the lambda function and we
can put in a five and a two for example
and we're going to see this print out
the result if we build our program let's
do that with gcc the bolt is going to be
good we can clear and run rooster we're
going to have result 1 is 30 which is 23
and 7 so the sum is 30. the second one
should say 54 because that's the sum and
the third one should say 7 because
that's the sum of 5 and 2 and it is what
we have here and after that we're going
to see that our program is done this is
how you can set up a lambda function
that returns something and we have seen
many ways we can work with us let's
comment this out because there is one
more thing i want you to see and that's
along the function whose return type is
specified explicitly okay we are going
to reuse the same lambda function we
have been using all along and we're
going to copy that
and we're going to go down and put it
down here and now we want to specify the
return type as a double the way we do
that we go after our parameter list and
we put in a dash symbol and we put in a
greater than symbol and then we're going
to specify the return type of our lambda
function let's say that we want our
return type to be ant this is how we say
it now our function here is going to
return end regardless of the types that
we put in so what the compiler is going
to do when we call this lambda function
it is going to take the parameters it is
going to add them up for example now
they are double so it's going to add a
and b as double it's going to produce a
double variable then it is going to
convert that to end and return it you
notice that now we have forced our
lambda function to really return a
specific
type here
before the return type was deduced from
the operation that we did here and
before we were returning double because
that's what the compiler was deducing
for a and b here to really drive the
point home let's assign this lambda
function to func one or func three let's
do that we're going to say func three
and this is a lambda function that is
going to explicitly return and and we're
going to set up another one which is
going to deduce the return type we're
not going to specify
the return type explicitly so we're
going to take out our return type here
let's do that
and we're going to go down and say auto
result 3 and we're going to say funk 3
and add up two double variables let's
set up these variables explicitly so
that you really see what is happening so
we're going to say it a and put in
a 6.9
why not and let's make this guy a double
because that's what our function here
expects and we're going to do another
one do double b and we're going to put
in a 3.5
for example and we are going to use this
variables as arguments here we're going
to say a and b and we're going to say
auto result
for
this should be funk 4 sorry for this
and i'm going to say result 4 and this
should say result i am making many typos
so we're going to assign our lambda
function the result of our lambda
function i should say to result for here
and we're going to pass in
a and b
now we want to see the types of result 3
and result 4 here we're going to go down
and print them out we're going to say
sddc out size of this is one way we have
to get
the types of our variables
we're going to pass in result three
we're going to say size of result three
and we're going to go down and say size
of result for okay we have our code in
place and what we want to see
is the type that is deduced by the func
3 lambda function here we are explicitly
turning the return type into end the
parameters we pass in are going to be
double that's what we have here we are
going to add up a and b and the result
of this is also going to be double but
the compiler is going to notice that we
are returning and explicitly here and it
is going to take this double result and
transform that to end and we're going to
get
and we're going to get the result of
that assigned to func 3 here for the
second lambda function here we are going
to automatically deduce the return type
so what we return here is going to be
a double type and we should see a size
of it for research 3 here printed out so
we should see a 4 on my system and for
the second statement here we should see
a size of double printed out this is one
way we have to try and prove this so
let's build this program and see what we
get okay the world is good we can clear
and run rooster and we're going to see
that this is exactly what we expect here
if we want we can even print result 3
and result 4 and see what we get so
let's do that we are learning so let's
experiment with this a little bit we're
going to say result 3 and we should go
back and say result three if i can type
e and dl here and we're going to go down
and say sddc out result for okay if we
build and run this
we're going to see the results printed
down the both is good we can clear and
run rooster
now we have result is 10 for the
first thing here for the
first lambda function and for the second
one result is 10.4 you can see that for
the first one the result was transformed
from double to and and for the second
one we deduced double so we still have
our decimal point here hopefully this
makes sense and this is really all we
set out to do in this lecture showing
you different ways you can set up your
lambda functions we saw the syntax of
setting up a lambda function we saw that
you can declare a lambda function and
call it through a name like func here we
went down and so that you can declare a
lambda function and call it directly
through the syntax you see here we saw
that how we could specify parameters to
our lambda function this is the syntax
and once you do this you have to
remember to call your lambda functions
with parameters like we see here we can
even use a handle given to our lambda
function and call our lambda function
multiple times after that we saw that we
could return something from a lambda
function and we had many chances to play
with us
and we
finished by looking how we could specify
the return type explicitly and the
syntax to do that is what you see here
we are going to stop here in this
lecture the next one we're going to see
how we can use our capture lists here
and make them do useful things
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to see how
we can use capture lists in our lambda
functions and do some useful things we
have seen that the syntax of our lambda
functions includes these angle brackets
here but we haven't really used them to
do anything for what we have done in the
last lecture they were empty all the
time in this lecture we're going to use
them here is a simple example of how we
can use our capsule list
we have two variables a and b they are
of double type and they contain these
values 10 and 20. but sometimes we want
to use thanks outside the scope of the
lambda function
inside the lambda function here and if
you set up your lambda function with an
empty capture list suppose you don't
have these two guys in
and you try to use a and b like this
you're going to get a compiler error
because
the body of the lambda function doesn't
have access to the outer context here it
can only use things inside the lambda
functions or events that you pass to the
lambda function here but it can't
directly access things outside the
lambda functions and we can have access
to thanks that are declared and defined
outside the lambda function through our
capture list if you look here we are
saying a and b and this is the syntax we
have to capture
these two variables a and b and have
access to them inside our lambda
function here and this is what capture
lists are really for giving you access
to things that are declared outside the
scope of the lambda function because if
you really think about it this lambda
function thing we have here is really a
type
so it is its own thing
that has these behaviors well then so
that we can call it and do things but it
doesn't really have direct access to the
outside
where it was declared and you have to
give it access through the capture
mechanism here okay now that you know
this we're going to see different ways
we can use the capture mechanism one
thing we can do is capture by value and
if we capture by value what we're going
to have inside the lambda function is
going to be a copy suppose we have a
variable here which is c the value is
going to be 42 as you see here we're
going to set up a lambda function and
capture our c variable
by value in this lambda function here
and what we're going to do outside the
lambda function notice the lambda
function has a handle so we can call it
we're going to loop five times
and at each iteration we're going to
call our lambda function and print the
inner value here
but after that we're going to increment
our c variable and this is going to
increment the
outer variable here and what we want to
see is that the changes we are doing on
the outside here are picked up by the
inner value that we have in our lambda
function here and ahead to break it to
you this is going to not be the case
because what we have inside the lambda
function is a copy of the outside
variable here so what we're going to
have is for the outer value to go from
42 all the way to 47 we're going to go
five times incrementing this little guy
but the thing on the inside is not going
to change because it is a copy the
incrementation here is affecting the
outside variable here but it is not
affecting the copy we have inside our
lambda function so for all these loops
here we're going to see 42 print it down
and we're going to see this in a minute
when we hit visual studio code let's say
42 correctly
excuse my typing here okay so now you
know that we can capture by a value and
you know what this really means another
thing we can do is capture by reference
and the syntax to do that is to add an
ampersand symbol in front of the
variable that we capture here and if we
do this and run the semicolon we run in
the last lecture we're going to see now
that the changes we do on the outside
are going to be picked up by the inner
side of our lambda function because we
are capturing by reference what we have
inside our lambda function here is a
true reference to the outside the
variable here and we're going to see
that now the outside and the inside are
going to be incrementing together and
we're going to have 43 42 44 and things
like that printed out on the console
okay this is really all i have to share
with you in this lecture showing you how
you can use your capture lists and that
you can capture either by value or by
reference we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with this a
little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
capture lists we're going to grab our
template files pretty quick and we're
going to put them in place we're going
to
put them in the current project and
we're going to open this guy in visual
studio code by dragging and dropping in
place here and we're going to open our
main cpp file clean it up a little bit
and close the left pane here what we
want to do in here is uh learn a little
more about capture lists and we're going
to put in a piece of code to play with
just that we have two variables a and 10
here and we have our lambda function
setup and let's take out our capture
list so that you can see the compiler
error we see
if we try to use them as is here so we
have our two variables and we have a
lambda function set up here and inside
the lambda function notice that we are
trying to access the variables that have
been declared on the outside of the
lambda function here and by default if
we try to do this we're going to get a
compiler error because these two
variables don't exist in the scope of
the lambda function here let's bring up
a terminal and see what visual studio
code is saying about this
and it is going to say an enclosing
function local variable cannot be
referenced in
lambda body unless it is in the capture
list and you see that this is really
descriptive okay we have sent this error
but we want to see what the compiler
says about this we're going to pass this
through gcc and we should get a similar
error it is going to say a is not
captured and it is going to go down here
and say b is not captured here and this
is the error we are trying to use
outside variables in our lambda function
but to really do that we need to capture
a and b
and the syntax to capture our variables
is to put them inside our angle brackets
here with a comma separate to the list
of the variables that we want to capture
so we're going to say a comma b because
that's what we want to capture here and
the moment we do that
visual studio code should be happy it is
not happy i think we need to compile
this for it to be happy so let's do that
and you see now
our variables are being captured and we
are summing them up and we are printing
the result of adding them up here by
calling the function through a handle we
have set up here hopefully this is
really making sense let's build the
program again
so let's use the gcc
you're going to see that the world is
good we can clear and run rooster we
should see a plus b is 30 but the values
are getting inside the lambda function
through our capture list they are not
going through the parameter list here
this is really something you need to be
aware of
now that you know how capture lists work
let's see that you can capture either by
value or by reference and we're going to
see what that means exactly i am going
to go down here and put in a piece of
code to play with capturing by value
okay let's do that we have a variable
called c the value is 42
and we set up a lambda function which is
going to capture c
with this syntax here and this is the
default syntax we saw
like we did on top here so we are going
to be capturing like this and if we do
this we're going to be capturing by
value the meaning of that is that what
we have inside our lambda function is
not going to be the original value here
it is going to be a copy of what we have
there
what we can do here is use this thing in
a loop and really prove this
so we're going to loop five times from
zero all the way to four because this is
going to go until i is no longer less
than 5
and inside we're going to print the
outer value which is going to be
the c here after that we're going to
call our lambda function which is going
to predict the inner value in the lambda
function and we're going to see that the
incrementation we do on the outside
which is going to affect the outer value
here is going to be visible inside the
lambda function here and that's not
going to be the case the change we do
here is not going to be picked up by the
lambda function here because what we
have inside is a copy so what we're
going to see is for the outer value to
go from 42 43 43 45 and it is going to
go until we hit the end of this loop
here but the inside value is not going
to change because the change we do in
here is not going to affect the copy
that we have in our lambda function here
hopefully this makes sense and again if
you have a problem please make sure you
ask
through the
course platform and i will do the best i
can to help you out for now we're going
to build and run this program you see
the world is good so let's clear and run
rooster you're going to see outer value
is 43 outer value is 43 outer value is
44 outer value is 45 the outer value is
changing but the inner value is staying
at 42
as you see here
hopefully this proves that the outer
value and the inner value are two
different things but we can even go
further and print the addresses of the
outer value and the inner value let's do
that
we're going to add that to our statement
here and say the address of this guy
so we're going to say address of outer
value or say address of inner value we
can say it like that
to really be descriptive in our terminal
here so we're going to say the address
of c
and on the outer value we're going to
add another piece of information and say
address of outer value and we're going
to say the address of c
and this is going to pick up the outer
value that we have here and this is
going to use the inner value we have in
our lambda function here
let's try and work and hopefully these
two addresses the inner and outer
addresses are going to be different
that's what we want to see here and
really proving that what we have inside
the lambda function is a copy through
the capture mechanism so let's run the
program the world was good so the outer
value the address is the e4 the inner
value the address is de0 we are proving
that what we have inside our lambda
function is really a copy so this is how
you can capture by value and that's
going to make a copy but sometimes you
really want to capture by reference and
we're going to see how you can do that
so we're going to comment out the code
to capture by value here we're going to
grab the code and reuse it because
that's going to be very similar to what
we had before we're going to say capture
by reference we're going to put in our
code and we're going to change it a tiny
bit what we're going to do is add an
ampersand symbol
in front of our variable here that we
are capturing and we're going to say
ampersand
the moment we do this what we have
inside the lambda function is no longer
a copy it's going to be a true reference
to the outer value here and now the
changes we do to our outer value are
going to be visible inside the lambda
function here and you're going to see
the addresses to be the same
let's build and really see this we're
going to use gcc to build our program
the world is good we can clear now and
run rooster and we're going to see that
the outer value let's make sure we have
some spaces after these guys and let's
go up and do that and both again because
things are really cramped together and i
don't like this
so the boost is good we can clear and
run rooster
so we're going to see the outer value
and the inner value are changing
together and the addresses are now the
same
because we have captured by reference
the inner value and the outer value are
referencing the same variable we have
outside here this is really all we set
out to do in this lecture i hope you
found it interesting the main idea was
the capture mechanism we have with our
lambda functions to capture thanks
outside the context of lambda functions
we can capture by specifying a comma
separate to the list of the variables
that we want to capture and we have the
option to either capture by value by
using
the variable directly in the capture
list like we do here or by prepending an
ampersand symbol here and capture by
reference and you are going to have to
choose whichever way you want to capture
your variables now that you know about
all these options here
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
see how we can capture everything from
the outside context to the lambda
function
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in the last lecture we
saw that we could capture things outside
the context of the lambda function now
we want to see that we can capture
everything living outside the context of
the lambda function the syntax to do
that is ridiculously simple if you want
to capture everything by value you just
put an equal sign in your lambda
function capture list and if you do
something like this now you're going to
have access to everything outside the
scope of the lambda function for example
we can access the c variable here from
the lambda function but if we have any
more variables declared outside the
scope of the lambda function we will
have access to them inside our lambda
function here again this is enabled by
the syntax that we use here by putting
an equal sign inside a lambda function
notice that if you use the equal sign
like we do here we're going to be
capturing by value what we have inside
the lambda function is going to be a
copy if you don't want to capture all by
value you can capture all by reference
and again the syntax is really simple
all you have to do is put an ampersand
symbol inside your capture list the
moment you do this you're going to have
access to everything outside the context
of your lambda function but that's going
to be by reference what you have inside
the lambda function are going to be true
references to the outside variables and
you can do pretty nasty things with them
because the changes you do inside the
lambda function are going to be visible
outside the lambda function and any
change you do from the outside is also
going to be visible inside the lambda
function so if you do this make sure
this is what you want and you can use
this to your advantage okay now that you
know this we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with us a
little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
capture all lists we're going to
grab our template files pretty quick and
we're going to put them in place and
we're going to open this little guy in
visual studio code let's do that we are
going to have our folder open we can
open our main cpp file clean it up like
we always do and we're going to close
the left pane here the first thing we
want to do is to capture everything by
value and we're going to put in the code
to do that which should be very easy to
understand by now and again the syntax
to capture everything by value is by
putting an equal sign within your
capture list you have to put that within
these angle brackets and that's going to
capture everything by value now now if
we run the program we're going to see
that c has been captured by value if we
look around we're going to see that the
outer value is going to
change but the inner value is going to
stay the same this is the same behavior
we have seen before by capturing by
value so let's build again we're going
to build with gcc the world is good we
can clear and uh bring up a terminal so
that we can clear properly so let's do
clear and run rooster now we see that
the outer value is changing but the
inner value is not changing and again
this is classic capturing by value if
you want to capture all by reference
you're going to use the ampersand symbol
here and let's do that we're going to
comment this out and we're going to take
this out and uh
use the code here we can do that we're
going to go down and put in a code and
say that we are capturing by reference
we should say capturing all by reference
and all we have to do to make that work
by reference is to put our ampersand
symbol within this angle brackets here
and this is going to capture everything
by reference if we run now we're going
to see that the changes we do from the
outside are going to be visible from the
inside here
let's weld with gcc and see that this is
actually the case the bolt is good as
you see here we can clear and run the
rooster we're going to see that the
outer value is 42 the outer value is
changing and the inner value is changing
as you see in our output here and this
is really how you can capture
by reference just to play with this
we're going to set up another variable
call it d and we're going to say it
contains a 5 and we can try to print
that inside our inner value here and it
is going to work you're going to see
that it has been captured we can say
sddc out inner value let's say that it
is the d variable we are trying to
access here and we're going to say d and
it is going to be visible inside our
lambda function here because it was
captured by reference here let's build
again we're going to use gcc to do that
the bolt is good we can clear and if we
run booster we should see d printed out
multiple times d
d
d and we are able to access it through
the capture mechanism and we are
capturing everything in the context by
reference here this is really all we set
out to do in this lecture i hope you
found it interesting i hate to say it
but this happens to be the last lecture
in this chapter on lambda functions we
still have a lot to learn about lambda
functions but unfortunately we don't
really have enough tools to understand
that now but for now we're going to stop
here and learn a little more things
about c plus plus then we're going to
come back and see some crazy things you
can really do with lambda functions i
would like to welcome you in this new
chapter where we're going to be learning
about function templates function
templates are a mechanism we have in c
plus to set up blueprint for functions
and have one point of control to set up
the function but the compiler is going
to generate the actual function that
gets called when it sees the function
call so this is going to solve the
problem we had before with function
overloads if you look at the code here
we have multiple overloads for the
maximum function but what we really are
doing in the body of these functions
is the same and suppose you have
12 or 13 or 20 overloads of the same
function you're going to be basically
repeating the same logic in the bodies
of this function and this code
repetition is bad function templates are
an effort to
solve problems like this the way they
work you set up a blueprint for your
function and this is the syntax to do
something like that you say template
type name t here don't worry about this
syntax we're going to have a chance to
go through it in detail but if you do
things like this this is going to be a
blueprint for your maximum function and
the compiler is going to use this
blueprint to generate an actual function
when you call this function and this is
going to make things super easy i
realized some of this is really cryptic
so let's head over to the next lecture
and let you set up your very first
function template go ahead and finish up
here and meet me there in this lecture
we're going to set up our very first
function template and again function
templates are a mechanism we have in c
plus plus to avoid code repetition for
example if you are setting up function
overloads if you look here we have our
max function and we have multiple
overloads for this function we can call
it with and double and string view here
but if you look inside you see that we
really are repeating the same logic
and it is even possible to have dozens
of overloads if you want to support tons
of types for your function
and this code repetition is really bad
function templates are a mechanism we
have in place to avoid things like this
and what you do
you set up a function blueprint using
the syntax you see here and your
function template is going to be
prefixed
with this template type name teeth and
here type name t is going to be in this
angle brackets
and then you're going to put the
blueprint for your function t is a
placeholder for the types that you use
in your function you see that t is in
the return type here it's in the
parameters that we pass to the function
and because it is the same character
here all these things have to be of the
same type the return type the first
parameter the second parameter they have
to be of the same type okay so once you
have your function template set up like
this you're going to implement it like
we see down below here it is nothing
complicated we just set up the prototype
for the function on top
and inside we put our implementation you
see here we have separated this into
function declaration and function
definition but inside you see that it is
the same logic we had to compute our
maximum between these two parameters
that we pass to this function
so how does this work when the compiler
sees you call this max function for
example as we are doing here it's going
to look at the types that you pass in
and in this case a and b
are of ant type so it is going to
replace the t in here for and and it is
going to generate a function initial
code
and this really brings up a big point
about function templates many people
think that function templates are actual
c plus plus code they're not they're
just a blueprint from which the compiler
is going to generate the actual function
that is called by the compiler for
example when you issue a call like this
again
function templates are not real c plus
plus code they are just a blueprint that
the compiler uses to generate your
function
based on the arguments you pass to the
function when you call it so when we
issue the call like we do here an int
version of our maximum function is going
to be created so the compiler is
basically going to go in and replace n
and for t here the return type is going
to be nt the first parameter is going to
be end the second parameter is going to
be empty it's going to go in the
definition it's going to do that and
we're going to have an it function
if we issue a call with c and d like we
do here in the second line here then the
compiler is going to see that c and d
are of double type so it is going to
generate another function from this
blueprint here and it is going to
replace in double then we're going to
have another double function if we go to
the third line here we're going to do
the same we're going to call it with
strengths and it is going to generate a
stringed version of the maximum function
here so what we achieve with function
templates is to avoid
several overloads for the same function
and we have one point of control in our
code but the compiler is still going to
generate this function overloads but one
thing about this is that if a function
is not used for example if you never
call a maximum function with string
then the string version is never going
to be created the compiler is going to
generate the overloads that you only
call in your c plus plus program and
this is really all function templates
are all about they give you a mechanism
to set up a blueprint for your function
and then the compiler is going to
generate actual functions based on what
you call in your c plus plus code okay
we have saved this but i want to
emphasize this again
function templates are just blueprints
they're not real c plus plus could and
when we hit visual studio code in a
minute we're going to see a tool
that allows us to see how the compiler
instantiates your function templates
based on the arguments you call your
function with but keep this in mind
function templates are not real c plus
plus code the rio c plus plus functions
get generated by the compiler
when you call your function and another
thing i wanted to point out is that
once a function template instance is
generated for example the interversion
of our maximum function template then if
it is needed again the compiler is not
going to generate that again it's going
to see if there is one generator already
and it is going to reuse that okay this
is really all i have to share about
function templates at this point in this
chapter for now we're going to head over
to visual studio code and play with this
a little more okay here we are in our
working directory the current project is
trying out function templates we're
going to grab our template project and
one thing i should point out here is
that our template project has been now
updated to have the launch.json file
which is going to allow us to debug our
programs so you should use a template
that includes the launch.json file here
that's going to allow us to debug your
programs and we're going to do that in a
minute when we have set up the example
here so we're going to grab our template
files and put them in place and we're
going to open this little guy in visual
studio code by dragging and dropping on
top here this is going to do our job
then we're going to open up the main cpp
file and i think we should close the
left pane here we don't need it anymore
and we're going to clean this up a
little bit so one thing i want to do is
to first do things the bad way so we're
going to set up a max function
let's call this maximum
and it's going to take end parameters
and we're going to return the maximum
between a and b and the way we do that
we say a greater than b we are going to
use our ternary operator here we're
going to put a question mark we're going
to return a or b and this is going to be
our function but suppose we need another
function that works on doubles if we put
double arguments in here the compiler is
going to insert implicit conversions
from double to end this may seem to work
but suppose you use a parameter type
that is not convertible to end for
example you use a string or something
let's put in std string
here just for an example so we're going
to say maximum std strength
a and std strength b
and we should make these const
references because we're not interested
in modifying these strings here
let's finish the name here
and we're going to say const std string
reference a this is much better it's
going to avoid unnecessary copies of
strings and we're going to say const htd
string reference
be here then inside we're not going to
do anything different we're just going
to use the same logic okay let's do that
suppose you have another function
which takes what should i say long long
end if we need that we need to copy this
function and put that in okay we need to
do that and we're going to change this
to long long end and we're going to do
the same here
long long and our parameter and we're
going to say the same here and you see
we are setting up a lot of functions
with basically the same thing inside and
that this is a lot of code copies
suppose we have this function maybe 20
times it is possible or even worse the
logic in this function is really long
maybe 20 or 30 lines and we will have to
repeat this thing in aku so the
designers of the c plus plus language
saw this problem and they said why don't
we set up a one point of control
where we can set up our logic to do the
maximum and we let the compiler generate
actual
functions based on the arguments we call
our functions with and they came up with
function templates and that's what we're
going to see so we're going to take out
all the other functions and we're going
to turn this maximum and function into a
function template the syntax to do that
is ridiculously easy
so we're going to say template this is
what you say you put an angle bracket
and you say type name and you specify
the placeholder for the type in this
angle brackets here this is the syntax
you have to use
then you have to specify your function
in terms of this placeholder t it is
going to take the place of the type so
for example here we want to return and
we're going to change this to t and the
parameters are going to be taken by
value t and t
let's do that
and now we have a legal c plus plus
function template it is going to take
this template here and use it to
generate actual c plus plus functions so
for example if we go in the main
function here and say ent result
equals max maximum we should say and say
x and y for example let's create these
variables on top here so we're going to
say ent x and we're going to put in a
five and we're going to create a y and
put in a seven why not now this function
is going to store the result and print
it out
let's do that so that we can see that
this actually works so we're going to
say result and say results this is going
to do and if we build and run this
program we're going to use gcc you're
going to see that the world is going to
be good
and uh world finished successfully we
can run this program like we always do
let's bring up a terminal and clear a
little bit and run rooster you're going
to see that we're going to see that
result now is 7 because that's the
maximum you see it is working here so
how is this mechanism working here the
compiler is basically looking in the
main function here and it is noticing
the call and it is going to look around
and see if it can find a declaration for
the maximum function here it's not going
to find it because there is none then
it's going to look at the function
templates it has in here and it's going
to see that it can do a replacement and
replacing the types that we are passing
in here so it is going to do that it is
going to take this template and it is
going to replace
t by end and then it is going to
generate a function that basically looks
like what we have here we're going to
copy this and we're going to put this in
the compiler is going to take the first
t here it's going to turn that into a
net it's going to take the second one
here it's going to turn that into an end
it's going to take the third one here
and turn that into an it and we're going
to have a function definition for the
call here this is what the compiler is
going to do
one thing some of you might be thinking
is there a way to really prove this and
somebody was nice enough to design a
tool
to let us see
this function or template instances
generated by the compiler and i happen
to have that opened it is a web-based
tool so you can use this in your browser
just go to
cppinsights.io
and then we're going to grab the code we
had in our main cpp file we're going to
copy it all and we're going to go back
to our browser and remove whatever i had
in here because i don't want this
anymore and i'm going to put in my
function template if we want we can even
take this sddc out statement because we
don't want all the junk that comes with
that we are just interested in looking
at the template instances
generated by the compiler now that we
have the code in here we're going to see
what the compiler generates because of
the call we have here i think i could
increase the size of the font here so
that you guys
can see this i think this is a little
better
then if you hit this play button here
let's click on it it's going to do its
processing and then the code generated
by the compiler is going to show up to
the right here you see it has detected
that we have
called the function template on line 13
here you see this line is highlighted
and then if you go to the right we're
going to see the functions generated by
the compiler so if you go here you see
that we have an interversion
of our function template and another
thing i should prove here is that
template instances that are not needed
are not going to be generated by the
compiler another way to say this the
compiler is only going to generate the
template instances it needs and again a
template instance is what you have here
the function the actual function that is
callable by the compiler generated from
your blueprint so if for example we
change the type of our
parameters to double let's do that okay
so we changed our types to double we're
going to hit the play button again
you're going to see that now it is going
to generate a double function here you
see that here if we change this for
example to
what can we use let's use long long end
like we did in our lecture we can do
that we can say long long and and if we
hit the play button that's what is going
to be generated by the compiler so
hopefully this proves that the compiler
is only going to generate the instances
that are needed for the calls you do in
your c plus plus program and this is
really function templates are all about
okay now that you know this let's set up
a few more examples to see that this
really works
so let's change the types of these guys
to
double let's do that and we're going to
play with this a little more in visual
studio code and let's use double
liters 5.5 and 7 or
78.7 here let's do that 78.7 and we're
going to build this and one thing i
should point out is that template
instances are generated when the
compiler is doing its job and then they
are going to be put
in the binary representation of your
source code so the world is good as you
see here we can clear and run a rooster
we're going to see that the result is 78
and it is transformed to end because we
are assigning to end here to really get
to the correct results here we should
use auto type deduction if we do that
the compiler is going to deduce the type
of result here based on the return type
of this function or the function
template instance i should say
now we're going to change this to auto
to do auto type deduction
and if we both again we should see a
double printed out correctly the both is
good we can clear and run the rooster
now we have the correct value printed
out from our function template here
let's change this to std string we can
do that so let's include
a
the string library
and we're going to change these two guys
to std string why not std string x is
going to be a string electro let's use
hello for example and uh for
y we're going to say std strength and
we're going to put in a world here okay
this is going to do and you notice that
we don't even have a compiler error
visual studio code is not complaining
the compiler is going to look at the
types we call our function with then it
is going to generate is an sdd string
version of this function and what it is
going to do it's going to replace in t
and replace that for std strand we can
actually put this thing entirely in
cpp inside so let's copy this code
before we run it so that you can really
see what is happening here we're going
to take out whatever we had before we're
going to put in our code and then we're
going to hit the play button here it's
going to generate our thumb we wait for
it to do its thing and if you look here
you see that it has generated
std strength this is really a compiler
representation of std string we don't
have enough tools to really understand
this but hopefully you can see that it
has replaced t
with some other type we don't know yet
std basic string car it has a few things
inside that we don't really know yet we
will have to learn a few more things
about this as we progress in the course
but for now
i want to prove to you that the compiler
is doing the replacement you see t was
replaced by this thing here std basic
strength and we have angle brackets and
this entire thing is really hdd strength
in the eyes of the compiler okay now
that we know this let's go back to
visual studio code and run this we're
going to build with gcc as we always do
the world is good we can clear and run
rooster
going to see that the maximum is world
and this is going to be using the
greater than operator
and this is going to compare two
strengths based on this and we know that
w here comes after h
in lexicographical order so the
comparison that is done here is
lexicographical
for this strength here or i should say
it is comparing things in alphabetical
order in abcde and things like that okay
now hopefully you have a big idea about
function templates they are just
blueprints you use
to generate actual functions and this is
going to allow you to avoid multiple
function overloads as we have seen
before
one thing i want you to see
is that you have to be sure that the
logic you do inside your function is
supported by the types that you pass to
the function and i'm going to show you
what i mean here we're going to set up
another function template we're going to
say template type named we're going to
set up another one pedem and we're going
to use t here you can use
this however many times you want and
then we're going to set up the function
which is going to do a multiplication so
we're going to say t that's going to be
the return value and we're going to say
multiply and we're going to multiply two
parameters we're going to say t a and t
b okay and we're going to put in the
logic and we're going to just return a
multiplied by b this is our
multiplication operator in c plus plus
and we can use this function so for
example we can say we can comment this
out and we can set up two variables
we're going to say and x and we're going
to put in whatever we had before let's
put in five
and end to y we're going to say 7 i
think this is what we used before you
can really put in whatever you want and
now we're going to call the multiply
function template so what this is going
to do is to generate a function template
instance which is going to be of type
and it's going to do a replacement in
here and replace t with ant and then
we're going to multiply two end
parameters that are passed to this
function and we're going to return end
and if we do that we're going to get 35
printed out let's prove this we're going
to use gcc to bolt the bolt is good we
can clear and run rooster we get a 35 if
we change this to double it is going to
work so let's change this to double and
maybe put in five point one and
7.0 why not and then we're going to see
what we get we're going to build with
gcc the build is good we can clear run
rooster we get
35.7 this is what we expect
but watch what happens if we try
to use the std string types okay i want
you to see that so we're going to enable
our std strength variables here
and if we try to bolt we're going to get
a compiler error but i want you to try
and guess why why do we have this
compiler if we look at what gcc is
saying here
it is saying an instantiation of our
function template required from here and
no match for operator
multiplication here and this is the
problem
the compiler is going to do what it
knows to do it is going to do a
replacement in our function template and
it is going to replace t
by std strength because that's the type
we are using as an argument here the
problem is we can't really multiply two
strands if you try to multiply two
strands like we do here it's not going
to make sense what do you expect to get
if you multiply two strings it doesn't
make sense the compiler doesn't know
what to do with this operation it's
going to give you a compiler error okay
to really drive this home let's go back
to cpp insights
and put in the code here and see what is
generated by the compiler
you should use these tools to your
advantage because they really help in
understanding what is going on so let's
hit the play button here i just put in
my code and it is going to say
compilation failed because we have the
same error cpp insights needs to compile
the code correctly
to give you the template instantiations
but here you see that it is basically
giving us the same error let's try and
see the entire thing here and see if we
see the real error and we can't really
scroll around with this i'm having
trouble scrolling around here i can use
these buttons i guess okay so let's see
if we see the actual error and we're not
seeing it here auto result multiply
error generated so we're going to get an
error if we try to instantiate our
template with the types that we are
passing in here which are hdd strength
cpp insights isn't really helpful here
but hopefully you understand the problem
the problem is if the compiler tries to
generate a template instance using std
strand multiplying two strands isn't
going to make sense so the compiler is
going to give you a compiler error
because this is not supported so the
message here is that you should make
sure that the template instances
generated by the compilers support
whatever operations you are doing in the
body of your function template this is
the message here
another thing i want you to see before
we close this off i'm going to take out
this
problematic line here and we're going to
go back to our maximum function what i
want you to see is that if you pass
different types for this function
template you're going to get a compiler
error and what do i mean by that let's
take out our std strength because it's
no longer useful for our purposes here
and we're going to just use double and 8
parameters let's use ant here
and we
make this an intellectual
and then we call our maximum function
you see that we have a squiggly line
because the function template is forced
to use the same type for the return type
the first parameter and the second
parameter here because the placeholder
is the same so the compiler is supposed
to use the same thing for the first
argument here the second argument and
the return type that we get from this
maximum function here but the problem is
we are passing in parameters of
different types and this is going to
give us a compiler error because the
compiler want to know what to do with
the types that you pass in as arguments
and if we look at our problems tab here
visual studio code should give us an
error no match for operator uh this is
the error we had before we can try and
build again we're going to get a
compiler error again but this time it's
going to be different it's going to say
no instance of function template maximum
matches the argument list that we are
using here which is double and end
so
this is a problem but we will see ways
around this as we progress in the
chapter but what you should know
is that if we set up a function template
like this this is going to enforce for
all the types where we will place in t
to be the same if they're not the same
the compiler won't know how to do its
replacement and it is going to give you
a compiler error okay the last thing i
want you to see is that we can use the
debugger to debug function templates so
let's turn this back to end because we
wanted this to compile
so let's take out the decimal point here
so that we have proper intellectuals and
if we compile again this should compile
okay the world is good now what really
happens if you try to debug a program
with
function templates
are you going to be working on the
template instances because remember the
function templates are going to generate
function template instances with actual
types for example our template instance
here is going to have ants because we
are passing ant as argument here so how
are we exactly going to debug this let's
try this we're going to set up a break
point here
on the call to our maximum function
and we're going to start debugging we're
going to go to our
run tab here
and we're going to use the debugging
tools that come with gcc we have seen
how to do that in the last chapter and
we're going to start debugging let's
minimize this guy here so that we have
some breathing room
and we're going to run our debugger
let's maximize this a little bit
and push this a little to the left
and we're going to start debugging and
see what really happens here so we hit
the green button here we're going to
start debugging our code is building now
the build is done
the binary has been passed to the
debugger and now we have hit our break
point here so let's minimize this a
little bit so that we have an easier way
to see this we have hit or break point
you see the locals are what we have in
the main function which happens to be to
the top of the call stack here
okay now we want to jump into the
maximum function and see the types that
we have inside
so what we want to do here is head the
step into function and you notice it is
going to jump into our function template
here but the locals here are not giving
us the types and this is because this is
a function template it's not going to
give you the types
because it's not easy to get those here
but if we look at the call stack you see
that we have information about the types
of the function that is being called we
are calling it a and it b
and it is going to return and you see
that in the angle brackets here and
again this is possibly another way to
look at what template instances were
generated by the compiler because we see
the function called here is taken into
parameters and it is going to return end
let's kill our debugger because this is
really all we want to see and change the
types to double here and we're going to
see that the function to the top of the
call stack is going to be
taking double parameters so let's change
this back to five point something 5.5
maybe 7 and 0.9 why not and we're going
to print our results here
but uh what we really are interested in
is seeing the function template instance
generated by the compiler because of
this call here and we can do this
through the debugger this is a little
bit convoluted because you have to set
up breakpoints and whatever but it is
helpful if you don't want to use things
like cpp insights as we have seen before
and again this is also useful because
you will need to debug your code if it
is using function templates let's run
this to really prove our point here
the world is going to go through the
binary executable is going to be passed
into
the debugger and we're going to hit our
breakpoint here again you see our locals
are not giving us the types here but we
cannot use
the function call stack to really see
this we have hit the breakpoint here at
line 15 so we can step into the call
and if we hit the body of the maximum
function here and look at the call stack
we're going to see that the parameters
we have in our function call are of
double type and again this hopefully
proves to us
that the compiler has actually generated
a double
function template instance okay since we
are debugging we can actually try and
follow this program let's hit next so
that we can hit the end of this function
we can
finish it and hit the main function by
the moment we hit the main function
results is going to be 7.9 which is what
we have here and it is what we're going
to print we can just step over this
because we don't want to step into the
logics of sddc out so step over we're
going to print our result and our
debugging session is going to basically
end because we have hit the end of the
main function let's try and use the
compiler from microsoft to see the
information it gives us because these
things can be different depending on the
compiler and the debugging tools that
you are using we have the luxury to have
these two set up here so all we have to
do is switch the tool we want to use
here and this is going to be using the
one from microsoft if you are not on
windows or you don't want to use the
compiler from microsoft and its
debugging tools you can just use gcc and
its debugging tools here i just want you
to see different ways to do the same
things and that compilers and debuggers
can give us different information we're
going to try and debug with this so
we're going to hit the green button here
notice that this is going to be using
the compiler from microsoft if we look
at the world output here you see that we
are calling cl.exe
it is what we are using to build our
binary the binary is going to be passed
to the debugger and then we're going to
hit the breakpoint here as we know
and then we're going to have our output
here these are our locals
you see in the main function we don't
see the types of our locals why is that
i don't know why but we see the values
here in the main function
and if we hit the step into button to
jump into our maximum function a is
going to have this value b is going to
have this value and we look at the
template instance we can see the same
information but we are using a different
compiler this is really how you can
debug your code that uses function
templates and this is going to give us a
peek into the actual template instance
that was generated by our compiler this
is really all i had to share in this
lecture and before i let you go let's
summarize a little bit function
templates are blueprints we have seen
that the compiler is going to use those
to generate actual function template
instances real function definitions and
uh
declarations are going to be created
when you call the function with
arguments if the template parameters are
of the same type maybe t and t then the
arguments you call the function with
must also match otherwise you'll get a
compiler error we have seen this okay
here we have a point we haven't already
covered template instances won't always
do what you want a good example is when
you call our maximum function with
pointers so let's go back and really say
this
because i want this to cover as much as
possible about function templates
so let's go back to our code and we're
going to modify things a little bit okay
so what we're going to do here is take
out whatever we have here we're going to
set up into variables x and y
x is going to be 5 as we have seen
before and
y is going to be seven let's use this
and then we're going to set up two
pointer variables we're going to say
endpointer
px and we're going to initialize this
with the address of x nothing
sophisticated so far and we're going to
say end p y and we're going to
initialize this with the address of y we
can do this the problem is going to come
when we try to call our function here
with the
pointers let's use px and py to call
this function and py and what this is
going to do is to generate a template
instance that takes end pointer this is
what the compiler knows to do we're
going to take the types that we pass in
here which happen to be end pointer and
we're going to change the return type to
end pointer we're going to change the
first parameter to end pointer the
second parameter to end pointer and
we're going to compute the maximum
if we compute the maximum here we're
going to be comparing pointers okay
notice this and if we try to do that we
might not get what we want because what
we get now depends on the address used
to store these guys in memory hopefully
you can see that and let's try and debug
this program so that you can really see
this we're going to use the tools from g
plus plus or gcc
and we're going to try and debug it
let's do that it is going to run through
the debugger and what we're going to
have is our terminal here i think this
is not needed anymore so let's put this
to the right here and minimize a little
bit and now you notice that px contains
an address and py contains an address
hopefully you can see that in the body
of our template instance we're going to
be comparing these addresses because
we're comparing what we pass by value
here and what we pass are these two
addresses so whichever is the maximum in
these guys and i think that's going to
be dd4 here it is the maximum so
whatever is contained in px is going to
be considered the maximum let's kill
this because we have seen this
information so if we have a value in px
and that happens to be at a bigger
address it's going to be considered the
maximum let's see what we print if we
run this program we're going to build
with gcc let's do that the world is good
we can clear
and run rooster now you see result is
some address because we are returning a
pointer and printing that out but we can
easily dereference this and get to the
value inside this pointer let's build
again we can clear and run rooster this
is going to give us result is 5 and
hopefully you can see that this is
really bad and not correct we are trying
to compute the maximum between x and y
and we are seeing that the maximum is
five so how can five beat the maximum
between five and seven the problem is
we're not comparing the values here we
are comparing the addresses stored in
these pointers because that's what we
are passing here hopefully you can
really see this and we can prove this
again through our debugger we can run
this through the debugger we're going to
hit the breakpoint let's minimize this
so that we can see our terminal window
here and we're going to move this around
a little bit and now we have hit our
break point if we hit next to jump into
the function you see that what we are
really comparing are a and b here and a
contains a much larger address so it is
the pointer that is going to be returned
and if we dereference that we're going
to be dereferencing the pointer that
contains this x value and the message
here is that you should be careful
that your function templates are really
what doing what you want somebody might
do this if they are not careful just
pass in pointer and expect to get the
maximum but the compiler is just going
to compare pointer addresses and you're
going to get something you probably
don't expect okay this is what is meant
by template instances won't always do
what you want a good example is when you
call a maximum function with pointers
you're going to get a wrong value
possibly there are tools like cpp
insights which can show the template in
spatial instruments we have seen that
and again the arguments passed to a
function template must support the
operations that you are doing in your
function template we have seen an
example of this by setting up a
multiplication function template and we
saw that we had a compiler error if we
try to pass std strength arguments
because we can't multiply two strings
this is really all i had to share in
this lecture i apologize it turned out
to be lengthy but i really had to put
this in one lecture so that i can really
show you different sides of the same
things we are going to stop here in this
lecture and the next one we're going to
learn about template type deduction and
explicit arguments
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about template type deduction and
explicit arguments what we mean by
template type deduction is the mechanism
the compiler uses
to deduce the type it would use to
set up our template instance from the
arguments that we passed to our function
call here
for example the compiler is going to
look at a and b here in a call to the
maximum function and it is going to
notice that they are of into type and
then it is going to say okay you are
calling your function with it types and
i see that your function templates takes
three replacers in here so i am going to
replace these guys with and and it is
going to guess that from the call that
you make here there's no other mechanism
to help the compiler out this is really
what template type deduction is about
and for the first example here we are
passing an end parameter so
nt is going to be deduced for the second
function call we are passing in double
parameter so a double function template
instance is going to be generated for
the third call here we are using std
string parameters
so we are going to deduce a template
instance that uses hdd string here this
is what we mean by template type
deduction but we have seen that
automatic template type deduction can
really have problems especially if you
pass parameters of different types for
example if we call a maximum function
here with
a and c which happen to be end and
double type then we're going to have a
problem because this function template
can't handle
parameters with different types because
the replacer is the same the compiler is
going to enforce that all the template
arguments are of the same type and the
template arguments are going to be what
you pass in here so a and b must be the
same if they happen to be not the same
for example ant and double you're going
to get a compiler error
now we're going to see that we can use
explicit template arguments and again i
want to make it very clear the
difference between a template parameter
and the template argument a template
parameter is what you have in your
function declaration or a definition so
what we have in our function setup here
are template
parameters ta here and tb are template
parameters but what we have when we call
a function template is going to be
template arguments for example c and d
here
are template arguments and we're going
to be using this terminology in this
chapter and many more chapters to come
in this course make sure this is super
clear so what we're going to look at is
using explicit template arguments and
what this means
is a mechanism through which you can
force the compiler to use some type to
generate your template instance and the
syntax to do this is really simple it is
what we have here we say maximum and we
put the type we want
to use to generate our template instance
in angle brackets like we see here so
this is going to use double so this is
going to explicitly tell the compiler we
want the double version called and it's
going to generate that and that's what
is going to be called by this call we
have here a good benefit with this is
that now this is going to support
template arguments of different types so
if we make the call like this the
compiler is going to see that uh-huh we
are calling with intent double types
because a is ant and c is double
but it's going to see that you want
the
double template instance generated now
the compiler will have the possibility
to do implicit conversions from other
types to double and if this implicit
conversion fails then we're going to get
a compiler error so if you look here for
example
this is the example for that we are
passing in a and e and a is ant and e is
an std strength we cannot do an implicit
conversion from
std strength to double so this is going
to give us a compiler error and this is
really all template type deduction and
explicit arguments are about we can use
these things to really make our code
easier now that you have this understood
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with this a little
more here we are in our working
directory the current project is
template type deductions and explicit
arguments we're going to grab our
template files pretty quick and put them
in place and after that we're going to
open this in visual studio code let's
drag and drop on top of visual studio
code here this is going to open our
folder and we can open our main cpp file
and
set up our function template let's clean
this up a little bit and we're going to
set up our function template let's type
this out to just to practice so we're
going to say template and we're going to
say type name and we're going to say t
and if you want you can put this on a
single line but i prefer to put this on
separate lines but let's show you that
so we're going to say t here and we're
going to say maximum and we're going to
say the parameters they are going to be
of type t and we can pass them by value
just for now and after this we're going
to go in the body of our function
template and then we can return
whichever parameter is the maximum we're
going to say a greater than b here we're
going to use our ternary operator and if
a is greater we're going to return a if
b is greater we're going to return b and
this is our function here okay now that
this function is set up let's set up a
few variables to really play with that
so we're going to include the string
library because we're going to be using
it a little bit and we're going to go
down in the main function and put in our
few variables we have a through f here a
and b are end c and d are of type double
and e and f are of type std strand the
first thing we can do we can say auto
max and we can assign whichever is the
maximum between a and b and once we do
this we're going to have that maximum
stored in max here but what i want you
to see is what the compiler does when it
sees the code like this the compiler has
no other outside help
to know the function template instance
it should really generate it is going to
look at the types we have here a and b
it's going to see that they are of type
and it's going to see that it can use
the function template we have here and
it's going to use that and generate a
template instance that it's going to
take and and it is going to call it to
get our maximum here again we can prove
this through the debugger we're going to
set up a breakpoint we're going to go to
our run tab here and we're going to run
this through our debugger
we're going to build our thing and when
we hit the main function you're going to
see that a is 10 b is 23 which is what
we have here cd we have our values n and
std string because it is a compound type
or a custom type we can expand on this
and really see more information about
this but we don't have enough tools to
really understand this by now so we're
going to just to use this as a wrapper
on our stream information here now we
want to call the maximum function and
see what was generated by the compiler
and we can step into this function
because we have hit the breakpoint by
now
so if we hit step into we're going to
step into this function and we're going
to see that it is an int function
instance that was generated this is
enough for our purposes
if we change our call here to use c and
d we're going to generate a double
instance so let's do that we're going to
generate a double instance and if we
print this out we're going to see this
printed out but we can use the debugger
to really prove this not that we know
how to use it we don't have to look
through the terminal output window but
you can do that if you want you can set
up sddc out and print max here you're
going to see it printed out so let's run
our debugger we're going to see the
template instance that was generated
through the divider we're going to hit
the breakpoint at line 17 here
if we step inside we're going to see the
local variables for our function here a
and b
and we're going to have the maximum
function to the top of the call stack
and you're going to see that it is a
double instance for our function
template here
okay this is what we mean by
template type deduction it is the
default mechanism
that the compiler uses to know
which template instance to generate from
your function calls but as we have seen
in the last lecture this can be
problematic
one way this can be bad is if you pass
different types to the maximum function
here let's pass in a and c for example
or a and d this is going to work equally
well you see that we get a compiler
error because the compiler now it says
that we are calling with different types
but the template parameters here are
really of the same type they should be
of the same type because t is going to
be replaced for a single time so the
call we do here is going to fail and if
we run this through the compiler again
let's do that we're going to use gcc
we're going to get a compiler error and
it is going to say deduce conflicting
types for parameter t
and then double so it can't really know
which one you want you want ent or
double the compiler doesn't know and it
is going to give us a compiler error but
now we're going to see a mechanism we
can use to make this work and that's
going to be explicit template arguments
okay what we can do to do this we can go
down and put in our call we're going to
say auto and say result or max we can
call this however we want we're going to
say the name of the function and we're
going to specify
the template type that we want generated
for our function template here so if we
do something like this with double
inside angle brackets here we're going
to be basically telling the compiler
please generate a double template
instance for this call we are doing here
so if we pass in c and d for example
this is going to give us what we want
and we can print this out if we
want so let's say max okay this is going
to work if we build let's build with gcc
let's use that
the build is going to be good because we
are passing any double
arguments and if we run this we should
see our maximum let's bring up a
terminal window and a visual studio code
here so that we can use that to see
things running we're going to clear and
run rooster you see that we have our
maximum here but using explicit template
arguments like we are doing here is
going to allow us to even pass different
types for our template arguments and for
example now we can change the first
argument here to ba which is going to be
an end and we're going to leave the
second one to bd which is of type double
now the compiler is going to see that
we're going to generate a template
instance of type double and it is going
to know that it can do implicit
conversions for the arguments we pass in
here so this is going to work if we pass
an argument that is implicitly
convertible to the type we passed in the
angle brackets here and let's debug this
again to show you that we're going to
generate a double template instance that
is going to be called and give us the
maximum that we print here so we can run
our debugger by hitting the green run
button here let's minimize this so that
we can see
our terminal window and it is down here
let's grab it and put it to the left so
that we can really see things printed
out as we debug
we have hit the breakpoint here and we
have our local variables you can look at
this if you want it is basically what we
have in the main function here but what
we want is to step into this maximum
function
and we're going to see
the template instance that was generated
you see that it is of a double type here
okay hopefully now you can see that even
if we passed different values for our
template arguments i should say
different types because a is of type and
and d is of type double but we're not
getting a compiler error the compiler is
going to insert implicit conversions
from whatever arguments we pass here to
the explicit template argument that we
specified here again the explicit
template argument like we are doing here
using the syntax with angle brackets and
putting in our type is going to tell the
compiler please use this type and
replace that for t in our function
template here and generate a template
instance we can call to service this
call here and we're going to do implicit
conversions basically from
and to double because that's what we
want then d is going to be of double
type we're not going to do any implicit
conversion then we're going to call this
function we're going to return a double
from it because that's our template
instance and we're going to print that
out here this is what is happening and
we can prove that a double instance was
generated through our call stack here we
see the maximum function is taking in
double parameters and it's going to
return double as our explicit
template argument here this is the
syntax that gcc uses is using but we
know now that it is a double template
instance for a function call here okay
if you're not happy with what we are
seeing with the debugger you can also
use cpp insights to really prove this
let's open this up we're going to say
cpp insights
let's do that and we're going to have it
open here okay we're going to
erase whatever we have in here and we're
going to put in another piece of code we
have our maximum function i should say
template function or function template
and we have alcohol here and it is
passing different types a and d remember
the last time we did something like this
by passing in different types for the
template argument this guy failed it
couldn't really generate a function
template instance because the template
parameters we have on top here specify
that these guys should be of the same
type but now we are able to use
different types as arguments because we
have an explicit argument specified
let's run this and see the template
instance that is generated and you can
see that it is of double type we
basically replaced every instance of t
here with double and this function is
going to be called to service the call
we are making here okay this is really
all we set out to do in this lecture i
hope you found it interesting the main
message was template type deduction a
default mechanism c plus plus uses to
know which template instances to
generate from your function calls but if
the defaults aren't working for you you
can use explicit template arguments to
specify the template instance you want
to generate it we are going to stop here
in this lecture in the next one we're
going to see how we can pass template
parameters by reference
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
show you that you can pass your template
type parameters by reference and we're
going to look at a simple example to
really drive this home what we have seen
so far is that we can do things like
this and specify our t like this and
this is going to generate a template
instance that passes our arguments by
value for example if we pass in double a
and double b here for our maximum we're
going to generate a template instance
which takes double as parameters and
returns a double here and this is going
to be doing things by value okay this is
what i want you to focus on right now it
is that this is going to do things by
value so if we go in our function here
and compute the maximum you're going to
see that the addresses we have on the
outside are going to be different from
the addresses we have on the inside here
if we try to print them out but you can
also pass your template parameters by
reference and the syntax to do that is
ridiculously easy you just use this like
you would use any reference we say cast
t reference here and this is going to
just replace in whatever type that you
pass when you call the function here for
example here we are passing in double
arguments so this is going to deduce a
double template instance which basically
says cost double reference maximum cost
double reference a and cost double
reference b and this is going to be the
function that is called so this is going
to really do things by reference and the
values we have inside a function
template body here are going to be true
references to the values we have on the
outside if we happen to do any
modification inside the body of the
function the modification is going to be
visible on the outside what we're going
to be doing in this lecture is just
printing the addresses here and we're
going to see that they are the same here
on the outside and inside the body of
our function template here okay this is
what we want to really play with in this
lecture but before we head over to
visual studio code i want to show you
that you can confuse your compiler if
you are not careful if you set up these
two function templates you see here
they are going to be overloads and we
can use function overloads with
templates but for now we're just going
to focus on the parameters that we are
passing in here the first one is taken
thanks by volume
and the second one is taking thanks by
reference as we see here
and if we issue a call like this we're
going to have the same problem we have
seen with function overloads before this
is not going to know whether you are
calling by value or by reference and
this is going to cause a compiler error
i really want you to be aware of this
okay now that you know this we're going
to head over to visual studio code and
really play with us a little more okay
here we are in our working folder the
current project is template parameters
by reference we're going to grab our
template files and put them in place so
let's do that and we are going to open
this little guy in visual studio code by
dragging and dropping here the folder is
going to open up we're going to open it
and we're going to close the left pane
here and clean up our main file here and
we are going to put in our function
template one thing i want you to see in
this lecture is that it is possible to
separate these things into function
declaration and function definition
let's just try and do that here so that
you can really see this and then you're
going to have to choose what you like a
little more so let's grab a function
header here and use that as a prototype
we're going to put that in front of the
main function and that's going to be our
declaration and if we go down after the
main function here what we have is our
definition this could work and this is
going to generate template instances for
the calls we do in the main function
here okay now that we have this we can
head in the main function and really
play with the function template here
we're going to set up two double
parameters and we're going to call the
function for example we say addon result
and we're going to call the maximum
function and we're going to pass in a
and b this is going to do
default template type deduction and it
is going to generate a double function
template instance here but what we
really want to prove is that this is
going to pass things by value and one
way we have to prove this is to bridge
the addresses both on the outside and on
the inside of the function here you see
we are already doing that in our
function template body we are going to
print the address of a so we can really
grab this and we use this stdc out
statement
and we are going to change it to say out
here and we're going to print the
address of a let's grab this again and
use this after the function call and
what we expect to see
is some address on the outside so for
example we may have something like zero
x and a one one one abc which is some
hex number here and that's the same
thing we're going to have on the outside
because the value we have before the
function call and the value we have
after the function call are going to be
leaving at the same address but what we
have inside the function body is going
to be a copy so it's going to live at
some other address for example let's say
d a
and uh the main point here is that what
we have on the outside is going to be
different from what we have on the east
side and hopefully this is going to
prove that we are passing by value so
let's print out our maximum here and see
the addresses printed out we're going to
build with gcc and we're going to build
successfully we can bring up a terminal
to play with us a little more we can
clear and run rooster we're going to see
that the address on the outside ends in
dd8 and the address on the outside ends
with dd8 after the function call but
inside you see that we have a different
address and this is going to tell us
that we are passing by value and what we
have inside the body of the function is
basically a copy again i don't expect
you to see the same addresses as me here
because your operating system is going
to set up the addresses however it wants
the main point here is that the
addresses you see on the outside are
going to be different from the addresses
you see on the inside here and this
proves that we are passing by value but
what if you don't really want to pass by
value and make your function template
work by reference well we can do that we
can change our function here to do
things by reference and all we have to
do
is use t reference like this okay and
when we start using references we really
need to be careful and make sure people
don't modify things without our
knowledge and a good practice is to mark
your things as cost references so we're
going to do that and we are going to do
the same in our function definition so
we're going to change this to cost t
reference let's do that and let's say
cost t reference for the first parameter
here and say the same for the second
parameter here and this should be it we
shouldn't be able to use this reference
to modify the data inside the body of
the function and our function is a
little safer but what the compiler is
going to do is really what it's been
doing all along it's going to look at
the arguments that we pass to the
function call here it's going to see
that it is double and it's going to do
default template type deduction so it's
going to generate a double template
instance for the function template here
and it's going to replace in double and
we're going to have const double
reference maximum cost double reference
a constant double reference b
and we can prove this by going into cpp
insight i think we can do that so we are
here in cpp insights we can take out
whatever we had we're going to put in
new code here and we can
hit the run button
to generate our instances and here we
have our template instance here
generated you see that it is going to
generate a double version of our
function template here and this is what
we have so const double reference
maximum and it is going to put in a
double explicit argument here but this
is business of the compiler what we
really care about is that it generated a
double template instance for our
function template here now if we run
this it is going to be passing
parameters by reference and what we have
on the inside should have the same
address as what we have on the outside
here so
to really drive this home we should
change
our address to abc to comply with what
we have on the outside here we can try
and build our program we're going to use
the gcc to do that the build is going to
be good we're going to clear and if we
run rooster we should see the addresses
being the same out d e 0 in d e 0 and
out d e 0 and you see now we are passing
our parameters by reference and if you
want to set up a function template that
passes template parameters by reference
this is how you can do this
and i think we can also try and debug
this and see if we can see any more
information on how this works we're
going to hit our run tab here and we're
going to hit the green button to start
debugging this program we're going to be
using the debugging tools from gcc
and we see our local variables here we
have hit the breakpoint and we have the
main function to the top of the call
stack this is what we have here and if
we try and step into the maximum
function we're going to see that the
template instance now is using const
double references and this is the
template instance that was generated i
think this is all we can really see here
and let's stop this and show you one
last thing
what i'm going to show you is that you
can't really have
the function template that passes by
value and the other one passing by
reference if you do that you're going to
have problems when you issue the call
like this because the compiler is going
to be confused let's change the second
one here to pass by value so we're going
to remove the cost reference here i
think it's going to do let's do that
pretty quick we'll remove the cost and
the reference we remove the cost and the
reference here and we use this guy as
our function prototype in front of the
main function here and how can we say
that we're going to go on top here and
say that okay we're going to put our
semicolon and this is going to be our
declaration but the moment we do this
you see that our compiler is going to be
confused because we have two possible
candidates for the call here it can
either be by value or by reference and
if we try to build this program we're
going to get a compiler error and it is
basically going to be saying what is
wrong here so it's going to say call
overloaded maximum double ambiguous
because we have two candidates again one
by reference one by value and this call
can be surfaced by both of these
candidates here so the compiler is going
to give us a compiler error and we have
no choice but to use either of these two
but we can't have them all
in our code and for example if we take
out the one by value here and leaving
the one by reference so let's comment
this out again if we're boiled we're
going to bolt you see the world is good
and we're going to print our data
however we have it in our code we see
the addresses are the same and another
thing i don't think i really proved to
you is that we are passing by const
reference here so the template instance
that is going to be generated is going
to be passing by const double reference
because we are passing in double
parameters but because of this cost in
front of our arguments here we want to
be able to modify the data referenced by
this name here if we go inside for
example and say plus plus a try to
modify a in any way through this
reference we're going to get a compiler
error let's work again and we're going
to see that and uh world finished with
an error
and it is saying
increment of read only reference a
because we are passing by const
reference here so you should really
remember this even if we are doing the
things in the context of function
templates
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture showing you that you can
set up function templates that take
parameters by reference and contrasting
this with passing by value and seeing
the differences between these two things
we're going to stop here in this lecture
and the next one we're going to learn
about template spatialization
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about template specialization and this
is a feature we have in c plus plus to
bypass the default mechanism of how
function templates work in c plus plus
okay let's make myself super clear here
we have a simple function template we
have seen a thousand times by now it is
the maximum function and it is going to
compute the maximum between a and b here
and it is going to return that it is a
function template so if we pass in a and
b which are of type and we're going to
generate a net instance of the template
here if we pass in c and d of double
time we're going to generate a double
instance of the function template here
if we pass in hdd string parameters
we're going to generate an std string
instance of this template here and this
is going to basically be comparing the
parameters we pass so we're basically
going to say if a is greater than b then
return a if a is not greater than b then
return b okay that's going to work if
what we're doing is what we have here
but the moment we pass something like
what we have here closed car pointers
then we're going to have a problem
because we're going to be calling our
function template with cost car pointer
parameters
the
default mechanism is going to deduce
a template instance that works on cost
car pointer arguments here and what
we're going to be comparing now are
going to be pointers to the string
rather than the string data itself and
hopefully you can see that this is going
to be a problem template specialization
is a mechanism we have to tell the
compiler for a template function
if i pass you this type please don't do
the default thing you do of replacing in
the
argument type for the template parameter
instead use the implementation that i am
going to give you and you tell that to
the compiler using the syntax we have
here you put a template keyword here you
put an empty pair of angle brackets and
then you specify your function the way
you want it you see it's going to return
a const card pointer the function name
is maximum which should be the same as
the function template here
it's going to be specialized for const
car pointer so we specify an explicit
template argument here and then we pass
our parameters which are also of cost
card pointer and when we do this then we
can head in the body of the function and
do the comparison however we want okay
so how do we do this comparison here
here is a simple implementation of the
function template we just saw on the
previous slide you see that it really is
the same thing we have the template
keyword we have our angle brackets and
we have the function header here it's
going to return cost car pointer it's
going to be called maximum and an
explicit template argument is specified
within these angle brackets and then we
have our parameters what is really
important about this function is that
it's not going to do the comparison
we've been doing all along it's going to
use a built-in function
and it's a c plus plus standard library
which is specialized for comparing c
strings okay if we come at cpp reference
here and look at a function called
htrcmp we have seen this before i guess
it is going to compare two null
terminated byte strings
lexicographically and you see this is
really what we want we have two const
car pointers one is going to be the
first parameter the other is going to be
the second parameter we're going to
compare them and look at the return
value we get from this function we're
going to get a negative return value if
the first parameter comes before the
second parameter in lexicographical
order we're going to get a zero if they
are equal
and we're going to get a positive value
if the first parameter comes after the
second parameter in lexicographical
order so we're going to use this
information here and compare
our two c strings here and return
something in visual studio code okay so
this is the function here it's going to
be using the logic from hdr cmp
and notice what we return we're going to
return whichever strength
compares the greater to the other so
we're going to do strcmp we're going to
pass in our two arguments here and we're
going to say
if this returns something greater than 0
return a because in that case
a is greater than b
lexicographically this is the comparison
we want to do here and otherwise you're
going to return b and this is going to
compare our strings and not compare
pointers directly which is what we are
trying to avoid here and you see that
template specialization is really
helping out here now if we have this n
and the compiler sees a call like this
it's not going to compare pointers it's
going to use the template specialization
because the compiler knows that this is
a better
fit for the call that we are doing here
because we are passing cost card
pointers this is how template
specialization works and it can really
come in handy if you are doing things
that work with pointers we are going to
head over to visual studio code and play
with this a little more okay here we are
in our working folder the current
project is template specialization we're
going to grab our template files
we're going to put them in place and
we're going to open this in visual
studio code by dragging and dropping on
top of visual studio code here this is
going to open our project and we're
going to clean it up a little bit and
we're going to close the left pane here
we don't need it anymore the first thing
we're going to do is to put in our
function template the same thing we have
been doing for a gazillion times by now
the maximum function is going to return
whichever is greater between a and b and
it is doing this by value after that
we're going to head over in the main
function and set up a piece of code to
really play with us we're going to set
up a few variables and we're going to
call our functions so we're going to say
maximum a and b this is going to return
the maximum between a and b the compiler
is going to deduce that the template
instance should be of ant type so it's
going to generate that and call it it's
going to give us the return value here
we can print it out and see it and we're
going to basically do the same
for double type and the string types
here and you're going to see that this
is going to work just fine so let's
build this we're going to use gcc to do
that the bolt is good we can clear and i
bring up a terminal to run this
and really see the output here we can
clear and run rooster you see max end is
23 because that's what we have here max
double 34
and that's what we have here and we
called max double to be of int type we
should use auto type deduction here to
avoid these mistakes
because the compiler can do this better
than us
that's what we're going to do and we're
going to deduce max sdr here and we're
going to build again let's weld with gcc
because that's my favorite compiler i'm
going to clear and run rooster now we
have correct output we have 23 which is
the maximum between a and b
we have 34.7 which was deduced to be of
type double here and then we have the
maximum strength which happens to be
world here again
when comparing strengths the default is
going to compare them
lexicographically and what that means
the one that comes after the other in
alphabetical order is going to be
greater by that logic world is greater
than hello and it is what we are seeing
printed out here okay this is working
just fine but what if we use cost card
pointers and try to call our maximum
function template and by that i mean
doing something like this we have two
variables
g and h which are of type cost card
pointers so they are c strings they are
going to be now terminated because we
are initializing them with a string
electron and we are comparing them here
we are saying maximum g and h and we're
going to print whichever is the maximum
after we return that from the function
when the compiler sees the call like
this it's going to do what it knows to
do it's going to replace an
scar pointer in our function template
here so it's going to return cost card
pointer it's going to pass the
parameters as coast guard pointers and
we're going to be comparing these
pointers here and we're going to return
whichever pointer is greater again here
you must be noticing the problem we're
going to return whichever pointer is
greater and we're not going to be
returning the actual string data we're
going to be returning just the address
and this can be really wrong because if
the addresses happen to be messed up
we're going to get the wrong output so
let's try and prove this again for that
i am going to comment out what we had on
top here because this could mess things
up a little bit
so i'm going to comment all this now and
i am going to debug this
so we're going to look at this line here
and i think we should say
cos car pointer result and i say equals
max c mom g and h and i printed the
result here this is going to make it
easier to step into this function
without the noise from stdc out here so
we're going to set up our breakpoint
here we're going to hit our
run tab and we're going to debug this
program and we're going to hit this
breakpoint here let's see the types that
we have inside our function call
so now that we are here we're going to
see that our locals are g and h and they
contain our strength if we go inside
we're going to see that g is really a
pointer to the first element in our
string here and it contains
w here
which is what we have here
and h is going to be a pointer to a
that's what we have here okay
and result is going to contain some junk
data because it's not initialized yet
but we can step into this function
and see things happening a again is an
address and b is an address you see that
the debugger is really smart it's
noticing that this is a pointer to a
strength and it's going to show us the
string here but what we compare are
these two addresses and you see that b
lives in a larger address it leaves at
address that ends in 55 and a lives at
the address that ends in 50. so if we
really execute this function we're going
to return the pointer to b but you see
that b is not really the greater string
and this is really something bad you
should be aware of this this is what the
compiler is doing by default and it is
going to give us a result that is not
correct let's close this and see a way
we can solve this problem and we can use
template specialization for this what we
really need is a way to compare c
strings and not compare pointers like we
are doing here we're going to do that
using a template specialization
and the syntax for this to work you say
template and you specify an empty pair
of angle brackets and then you specify
whatever function you want to use so
we're going to go down here and specify
that we want to return the cost card
pointer
the function is going to be called
maximum we're going to specify an
explicit template argument which is of
const car pointer because we want this
template instance to work for scar
pointers
so once we have this end we're going to
specify our parameters we're going to
say cos car pointer a and cost car
pointer b and we're going to head into
the body of our function template here
now we have our two parameters and we're
going to compare them as if they were
const color strengths and we have seen
that we have a built-in facility from
the c plus plus standard library it is
this htr cmp function we can use it to
compare two strengths and we're going to
use the logic that we have here so if
the first parameter is less than the
second parameter i am talking in a
lexicographical order we're going to
return something negative if they are
equal dexicographically we're going to
return zero and if the
first parameter is greater than the
second parameter lexicographically we're
going to return a positive value so
let's transform this logic into a
ternary operator we're going to say
return sdd str cmp we can say that and
if you have access to this function
we're going to need to include c string
let's do that we're going to include the
c string library and now we can say this
and we're going to pass in a and b and
we're going to ask ourselves is this
greater than zero okay if it's greater
than zero then if the first parameter is
greater than the second parameter let's
see graphically so we're going to return
a
if it's not the case we're going to
return b this is our ternary operator
here and it is going to work now that we
have this n the compiler is going to
know we have a template specialization
for a const car pointer if we call the
function like we did here calling the
maximum function the compiler is not
going to use this function template we
have on top here it's going to see that
this template specialization is better
for the cost card pointer type that we
are passing here and now if we try to
build and run the program the boat is
going to be good if we clear and run
rooster we're going to see that now the
maximum is wild
let's see what we see if we don't have
this specialization and we're going to
comment this out because i don't think i
really showed you we're going to build
again and again if we do this
this function template is going to be
used and you know that it is going to
deduce a function that compares pointers
directly and that's going to be really
bad we can build this with gcc and
really see what we get as output we can
clear and run rooster now you see that
we are saying animal is the maximum
between these two guys but that's not
true animal is less than wild in
lexicographical order we need a way to
really compare
c strings properly and our template
specialization
is really doing that using the htd crmp
function and it is working pretty well
this is really all template
specialization is all about you're going
to do this if the default function
template you have is really not working
according to your needs for the type
that you want to use for this and use
this to your advantage because it's
available to you and now you know how to
use this the syntax is really simple you
say template and you say angle brackets
and then you specify whichever
implementation you want for your
specific type for example here our
specific type for which we want to
specify this function template is cost
card
you specify that as an explicit
template argument and then you specify
your return value your parameters and
you do whatever logic you need to do to
do things right in the body of this
template specialization here i would
like to welcome you in this new chapter
where we're going to be learning about
concepts concepts are a mechanism we can
use to set up constraints or
restrictions on the template parameters
in our function templates for example we
can use this technique to say that we
want our function to be only called with
integers and if you call it with
something that isn't an integer it's
going to give you a compiler one thing i
should emphasize is that concepts are
one of the big four features in c plus
plus 20. so we're going to be learning
about this in this chapter we have just
said that we use them to place
constraints on our template parameters
but we saw that we could do something
like that in the last chapter where we
could use type trades and static
concerns for example if you look at the
function here it's going to print a
number but we have a requirement for
this number to be an integral type
through the static assert that we have
here we're going to see that we can do
something really similar with concepts
but it's going to be much cleaner and
that the logic to enforce our
constraints is not going to be in the
function body it's going to be somewhat
in the function declaration in the
constraints that we put on the template
parameter here we're going to see
specific syntaxes of how you can do this
starting in the next lecture there are
two sides to concepts in c plus plus
there are standard built-in concepts
that come with the c plus plus
programming language but if for some
reason these happen not to be enough you
can build your own and we're going to
see how we can do that later in this
chapter here are a few examples of
concepts you can use in your c plus plus
program you can use the integral
concepts to enforce that your parameters
be integrals you can use the floating
point concept to enforce that your
template parameters be of floating point
type you can do all kinds of crazy
things okay concepts are really cool and
they are going to make your function
templates much safer to work with we are
going to stop here in this lecture and
show you how you can use concepts
starting in the next lecture go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there in
this lecture we're going to learn about
concepts again concepts are a mechanism
we have in place in c plus 20 to place
constraints on our function templates
for example we can use concepts to
specify
that we want our function template to
only be called with integers or doubles
or strings or whatever
and when somebody violates our concept
they're going to get a compiler error in
this lecture i am going to show you how
you can set up your concept and the
different syntaxes you can use and how
we can understand them
but before we do that please note that
there are two sides to concepts there
are concepts that are standard and built
into the c plus plus standard library
and those are ready to use and these are
what we're going to be using in this
lecture but know that you can also build
your own concepts and use them to do
whatever it is you want to do here are a
few examples of built-in concepts we can
use from the c plus plus standard
library we have for example a concept we
can use to enforce
that people call our functions only with
integral types if they violate this
they're going to get a compiler error we
can also enforce for our template
parameters to be floating point we can
do all kinds of crazy things okay now
that you know this let's see how we can
set up a concept on our function
templates and this is the first syntax
we're going to look at all you really
have to do is to put in your template
declaration like we have been doing all
along you also have to add in the
requires keyword here after the requires
keyword you're going to specify your
concept and specify your template
parameter in angle brackets here
when you have this thing in front of
your function template like we have here
the function template can only work
right if the concept in here is
satisfied and this concept in this case
is going to be satisfied if somebody
tries to call this function template
only with integral types if they violate
that again they are going to get a
compiler error okay once we have this
concept set up we can look at the piece
of code that tries to use it and try to
guess what is going to happen here is a
piece of code we would set up in the
main function and try to call a function
template we have two variables of car
type we know that car is an integral
type so if we issue a call like this
this call is going to work the template
instance is going to be generated and
it's going to be called and give us the
results that we can print here this is
right on the second piece of code here
we have two variables of type and
we're going to call them we're going to
call our function template with and
and this is also an integral type int is
an integral type so this is going to
generate our function template instance
and we're going to call it and get the
results that we print here and if we try
to call our function template with
double types
the concept is not going to be satisfied
and we're going to get some kind of
error and our function template instance
is not going to be generated this is
really how you can use concepts to force
some rules on users of your function
templates if i can say it like that we
have been able to do something like this
using typed traits and the static
asserts in the last chapter but concepts
are much cleaner and that they are kind
of built into the signature of your
function you don't have to go in the
body of your function and set up static
asserts the function is already
supporting concepts when you declare and
define it and this is really cool okay
this is our first syntax we can use to
set up concepts
for our function templates using the
requires close after our template
declaration and following that with
whatever concept we want to enforce on
our function template here please note
that you can also use type traits
directly
in the required clause here and this is
going to work and this really says that
all you really have to put after the
requires close
is an expression that can be evaluated
at compile time but also results in a
boolean value once you satisfy these few
requirements you can really set up your
concept however you want you just have
to be careful that the expiration can be
evaluated at compile time and that it
evaluates to a boolean value and when
the expression evaluates to true the
concept is going to succeed if the
expression evaluates to false you're
going to get a compiler error because
the concept is not satisfied this is how
these things work now that we have seen
the first syntax i think it is big time
we looked at the second way you can set
up concepts and that's going to be in
your template declaration you're going
to say template put in your angle
brackets and inside instead of saying
type name t like we have been doing all
along you just specify your concept
directly and save the template parameter
like this once you do this this concept
is going to be enforced on this function
template here this is just another
syntax to really do the same thing we
also have a third syntax we can use if
we use auto to set up our function
templates and the way this works is to
just add your concept in front of the
auto keyword and once you do this the
compiler is going to enforce for the
first parameter and the second parameter
to this function
to satisfy the integral concepts so if
you have to use auto to set up function
templates this is how you can use
concepts to constrain
ways in which people use your function
we still have another way we can use
concepts in c plus plus and this is how
you do it you specify your template
declaration like we have been doing all
along you specify your function template
but after the parameter list as we see
here you're going to put your requires
close and you can put that in this place
here and it is going to work i realize
these are many syntaxes to process for
the first time but some of these
syntaxes are going to work better in
some situations and they are there just
to make it flexible for you to use
concepts in your c plus plus code okay
now that we have seen different ways we
can set up concepts for our function
templates i think this big time we
headed over to visual studio code and
tried them out okay here we are in our
working folder the current chapter is
concepts the current lecture is using
concepts we're going to grab our
template files we are going to put them
in place
and we are going to open this thing in
visual studio code by dragging and
dropping on top of visual studio code
here we do that this is going to open
our folder we're going to open up our
main cpp file and close the sidebar here
and we're going to clean things up a
little bit and we're going to set up a
function template which is going to add
two numbers we already know how to do
that so we're going to say template type
name and it's going to have a template
parameter of t then we're going to set
up the function like we have been doing
all along we're going to say add we're
going to say t a and t b and this is
going to return the sum of a and b once
you have the function in we can go in
the main function and set up code that
would call this function and if we try
to compile this program it is going to
work now because we are not placing any
constraints on this function template
here let's try to build with gcc like we
have been doing all along you see it is
going to weld okay you see the world is
good world finished successfully and if
we want we can run this application and
it is going to print result a
result b let's take this out because we
haven't done this yet but it's not going
to print result c but if we want we can
really print it it's going to work so
let's
put that in and we're going to say
result c and print result c here and
world again let's world now to take this
into account
world is good we can bring up a terminal
to try this out and we can clear and run
rooster now you see result a is 30
because that's the sum of a and b here
result b should be 16 which is what we
have result c is 13 which is what we
should get by adding these two double
variables
now we wanted to constrain this function
to only work if somebody passes integral
types and when we put that constraint in
place it is going to work if we add up
two character variables because they are
integral types it's going to work if we
add up two integer variables because
they are integral types but once we hit
this guy here
with the double variables we should get
a compiler error because the constraint
is not satisfied let's do that we're
going to comment the double thing first
because we want to really isolate it and
see it and see the compiler error that
we get and we're going to add a
constraint to our function template
using concepts okay if you want to use
concepts in c plus plus 20 the first
thing you need to do is to include the
library that gives us access to concepts
and we're going to do that by saying
include concepts this is easy now that
we have this end we're going to use the
first syntax we saw in the slides and
we're going to add the requires close
after the template declaration
and we're going to say std integral and
we're going to say the template
parameter here i think this is the
syntax okay watch what happens if we do
this down in the code we are calling the
function with car types
and
integer types so this is going to
compile fine because the concept here
is satisfied this concept is going to
enforce for the template parameters we
call a function template with to be
integral types let's build and see if we
get to compile successfully you see both
finished good everything is going to
work and if we run our program we should
see results a and result to be printed
out let's run the program we see our
result here now we're going to comment
out the others and leave in the double
example and we're going to uncomment
that and i want you to see the problem
we get when we try to use
our function template with double
variables here you see visual studio
code is already complaining it is saying
there is something wrong if we look at
the problems tab is going to say no
instance of function template add
matches the argument list but this is
really not descriptive enough but the
problem is our concept is not satisfied
by calling our function template with
double types because we clearly said
that we want the function to only be
called with integral types let's build
our program we're going to pass this
through gcc
and we're going to get a compiler error
that says that some concept was
unsatisfied
and we see we see in function main
use of function t add with double with
unsatisfied constraints and this is
really clear when we see an error like
this we will go and look at the
constraints that the function has and
we're going to see if we satisfied those
constraints by calling
like we did in the main function here
and we will know that the function
doesn't support non-integral types and
we will fix this problem this is really
how concepts can help
in writing safer function templates now
that we have seen the first syntax i
think it is big time we looked at the
other syntaxes so let's do that let's
copy the code here because we're going
to be reusing this a couple of times and
adapt it instead of typing this entire
thing the second syntax involves getting
rid of the requires close all together
and just using the concept instead of
type name here so i'm going to say std
integral and this is going to be enough
this is going to tell the compiler to
enforce this concept for this function
call
for all the template parameters that go
in the place of t here i hope this makes
sense now if we go back we see that we
still have our squiggly lines here if we
try to compile we will get the same
compiler error okay and you see we have
the same compiler error function add t
called with unsatisfied constraints i
think if you go down we're going to see
even more stuff out of this it's going
to say required the satisfaction of std
integral with t but now we are trying to
call this with double so this is really
going to lead to a compiler error so
this is the second syntax and it is
going to do the same thing now that we
have seen this we also have a third way
we can do this and that's through the
auto mechanism let's set up a function
using auto so we're going to say auto
add auto a and auto b we have seen that
we can do that in the last chapter and
we're going to return a and b a plus b i
should say if we do this you see that
the squiggly line goes away and we can
add these things up and print the result
the return type is going to be deduced
by the compiler automatically but know
that this is going to generate a
function template behind the scenes this
is just a nicer syntax we have to use
auto to set up functions that work for
multiple types let's build and uh see
how gcc handles this the world is good
because we have no constraints here and
if we run our program it's going to work
it's going to give us 13 as the sum of
11.1 and 1.9 but we can also place
constraints on this function here and
you do that by specifying your concept
in front of the auto keyword here so for
example we can say std integral and std
integral fold the second parameter here
let's say that and once we do this if we
go down we should see our squiggly line
on the call of the function here because
now the way we are calling this function
is not valid the function clearly says
that it wants to be called only with
arguments that satisfy this concept here
if we're trying to build again with gcc
we're going to get the semicompiler
error let's do that and it's going to
say use function with
unsatisfied constraints the same error
and if we go down we should see that it
requires the integral
concept to be satisfied here so this is
the third syntax you can use if you
happen to be using the auto syntax for
your function templates let's comment
this out because we still have another
syntax we need to learn about this is
going to be our syntax three and we're
going to comment this out and the last
one involves
just leaving in our function template
let's copy this because i don't want to
type this again we're going to go down
and say syntax form and put in our
function template we're going to take
this requires close we're going to cut
it out and we're going to put it after
the function parameter list
like this and this is going to be valid
c
syntax to enforce a concept on your
function template if we go down you see
we have this wiggly line and i should
prove that this works with other
integral types here let's just comment
out the double line here and uncomment
the other we had for car and ant if we
try to build this program now it is
going to work fine because the
constraints are satisfied but the moment
we uncomment the calls with double types
we're going to get a squiggly line which
is a good warning that we have a problem
but if we ignore the squiggly lines
and adjust build with gcc we're going to
get the same compiler error and it's
going to say that to call our function
we need to satisfy
the integral concept for the arguments
that we pass here and the double
arguments we're passing in here are
violating our concept so we get a
compiler error this is really how you
can use concepts in c plus plus i tried
and came up with simple examples to show
you different syntaxes you can use
concepts with
and this is really it try to get
yourself familiar with these syntaxes
and it's not going to be really hard to
use concepts in your c plus plus
programs okay this is really all i had
to share in terms of the syntaxes you
can use with c plus plus 20 concepts if
you go to the documentation you're going
to have more information about this but
we're going to do a few more lectures to
really drive this dancehall for now you
can come to cpp reference here and see
more concepts that you can use we have a
lot of this and we can really use this
to tune our function templates however
we want okay for example you see our
integral concepts you see a floating
point concepts and there are even more
that are usable with
classes but we haven't learned about
classes yet and we will do that starting
at the next chapter but now i just want
you to be familiar with concepts that
were introduced in c plus plus 20. and
here is another piece of documentation
you can look at just to complement what
we are talking about in this chapter but
i wouldn't recommend reading this just
yet because it's just going to confuse
you there is a lot of things we still
need to learn to really be able to
understand this so try to go through
this chapter and i am going to try and
break this down in ways that you can
understand this the main message is that
there are more concepts here you can try
in your c plus plus code if it makes
sense for the problem you are trying to
solve with c plus plus we are going to
stop here in this lecture in the next
one we're going to show you how you can
set up your own concepts in c plus plus
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to see
how you can build your own concepts and
this is going to bring us into the
second part of concepts we can use in c
plus plus in the last lecture we used
the concepts from the standard library
that are built into the c plus plus
programming language starting in c plus
plus 20. in this one we're going to be
building our own concepts and without
waiting anymore let's see how you can do
that and this is the syntax you can use
to do that and it is really simple the
way you do that you say a template
declaration specifying the template
parameter you want to constrain and then
you say concept you say the keyword
concept you give your concept a name you
put the equal sign after that and then
you're going to specify the requirements
for your concept so for example here we
are using a type trait to specify that
this type trait is going to determine
what works for this concept here and
what this is going to do is to enforce
for our template parameter to only be
integral if it's not integral we're
going to get a compiler error and one
thing i should tell you is that the std
integral concept is exactly built like
this in the c plus plus standard library
this is really cool so if you want to
set up your own concept and you want to
do that using typed traits you can do
that like this and it is going to
enforce for your template parameters to
satisfy that typed rate or to be exact
this concept is going to be satisfied
when the type trait evaluates to true if
the typed rate evaluates to false at
compile time the concept is not going to
be satisfied that's another way to look
at that down here we have another syntax
we can use if we have multiple
statements in our concept all you have
to do is specify the concept keyword you
give it a name you go to the equal sign
and then you add a requires close the
requires close is going to specify the
template parameters for which you want
to enforce your concept and then you're
going to put a pair of curly braces and
inside that you're going to specify the
syntax you want your concept to satisfy
for example here we want
for the two parameters to be
supporting the multiplication operator
if this multiplication operator is not
supported for the template parameters
that we passed the concept is going to
fail and again i should emphasize that
this doesn't check for the value of a
multiplied by b it's just going to
enforce from the syntax to be supported
so for example if you call a function
template with this concept and you try
to pass in integers it's going to work
because you can multiply integers but if
you pass two strings this is going to
fail because it doesn't really make
sense to multiply strings okay this is
the syntax now we only have one
statement to enforce inside but if you
want you can even put more statements if
you go down here we have another example
called incrementable this is going to
require for the template parameter to be
incrementable we specify the concept key
world we say the concept name we put in
our equal sign and then we say requires
we put on template parameter and put in
our requirements for any template
parameter that is using this concept the
syntax here must make sense so you must
be able to take the value that you get
from here and for example say i plus
equals one this is going to be valid
syntax you're going to say plus plus a
and plus plus b all these are going to
be valid c plus plus syntaxes for the
template parameter that you try to call
this function template with and if this
doesn't work you're going to get a
compiler error because your template
argument isn't really satisfying this
concept so this is really how you can
set up your own concepts in c plus plus
once you have your own concepts set up
you can use them like we have been using
the other concept from the ziploc plus
standard library for example we can use
syntax one to put a requires clues and
say that we want to satisfy our own
concept with this particular syntax you
will have to put in these angle brackets
and put your template parameter inside
this is the syntax you have to use you
can also use syntax 2 and specify my
integral directly in this angle brackets
in your template declaration and this is
also going to work we can even use this
with the auto syntax for our function
templates it is going to work okay now
that you have sent this i think it is
time we headed over to visual studio
code and play with us a little more okay
here we are in our working folder the
current project is building your own
concepts we're going to grab our
template files like we always do and
we're going to put them in place and
we're going to open this thing in visual
studio code let's do that we have our
project open here or folder i should say
we're going to clean this up a little
bit and we're going to include our
concepts library and we wanted to set up
our own concept the first syntax we're
going to see is by using type trades and
we're going to say template type name t
and we're going to say this concept we
want this template parameter to satisfy
we're going to say concept and we're
going to say my integral which is going
to be the name of our concept we're
going to put an ecosign and then we're
going to say
std integral v and specify that we want
this type trait to be satisfied for this
concept here and after this we need to
put in our semicolon and i think we need
to include the type traits library
because we are using that we should say
std is integral so sorry for this and
this is going to work now okay now that
we have the concept set up we can use it
like we have been using other concept
for example we can set up a function
which is going to add up two numbers and
it is going to use this concept here we
have multiple syntaxes we can use so
let's go down and try this out we're
going to say template and say type name
t and we're going to require this
concept to be satisfied for our function
template we saw that we could use the
requires close here and say my integral
and say the template parameter we want
to enforce this on and after this we're
going to just put in our function
template we're going to say add what we
have been doing all along in the last
lecture we're going to say t a
and t b and we're going to return a plus
b now this function is going to support
our concept let's go down and set up two
variables we're going to say and x
and we're going to say 6 for example and
into y and i'm going to make this a 7
why not and we're going to say add
x and y once we do this you see that we
have no problem because the concept is
satisfied for the arguments that we are
passing in here the concept is satisfied
because the type trait here is going to
return true for this type here because
it is an integral type when the type
trait returns true then the concept is
going to be satisfied if the type trait
returns false the concept is going to
fail let's try and bolt and really drive
this home you see that the world is good
our function is working so the function
template and stands for this code here
is going to be successfully generated
and we're going to call it when the
program runs
now let's change the type of these guys
to double and try to violate our concept
and make it fail once we do this you see
the call here has a squiggly line and a
visual studio code is not going to say
that it is a concept problem which is a
shame but we can still run this through
the compiler and the compiler is going
to tell us what is wrong so it's going
to say use of function add with
unsatisfied constraints and if we go
down we're going to see the exact
constraints we violated and we're going
to say required for the satisfaction of
my integral with t we are calling this
with double and double is going to
evaluate this to false hopefully you can
see that you can really set up your own
concepts using the syntax here and we
can use our concept with all the
syntaxes we have seen in the last
lecture so for example we can take out
the requires close all together here and
say my integral in the
template declaration here so we're going
to say my integral and if we do this
we're going to fail again because the
concept is not going to be satisfied
we're going to have the same problem we
can change the syntax to use the auto
syntax but before we do that let's
change this back to type name t and then
put our requires close after the
parameter list of our function template
we're going to say requires
and we're going to say my integral and
specify the template parameter and this
is a valid function template with a
concept applied to app and if we both
again we're going to get the same
compiler error so you see the same error
and we can use the auto syntax let's do
that we're going to take out the
template declaration here we're going to
take out the requires close here and
we're going to change our t to auto and
the way we do that we're going to say
std no no std we are using our own
concept so we're going to say my
integral auto this is going to work and
we're going to say my integral auto and
my integral auto here the moment we do
this you see that we have squiggly lines
here because our concept is violated but
if we're trying to build again we're
going to use gcc to do that the build is
going to fail you see that the same
concept is violated and we are able to
use our concept throughout the four
syntaxes that we saw in the last lecture
and this is really cool now that we have
this we're going to comment this out and
we're going to see that we can set up
concepts that have requirements spanning
multiple statements or multiple lines
okay let's go down and do that suppose
we want to set up a concept that is
going to enforce for the templates
parameters to be multipliable
with the multiplication operator we have
here we can use this syntax here we're
going to put in our template declaration
we're going to say concept we're going
to say the concept name we're going to
put in an equal sign and then we're
going to put in a requires close
with our template parameters and and
after that we're going to put a pair of
curly braces and inside the curlies
we're going to put the requirements for
example in this case we require for the
template parameter here to support the
multiplication operator between two of
these types if the multiplication
operator is not supported we're going to
have a problem and that this is the
concept that is going to enforce that
one thing you should know is that this
is just going to check
that multiplying a and b is valid syntax
it's not going to check the value of a
multiplied by b and you should really
understand this now that we have this n
we can set up a function to use these
two guys why not use the function we
have seen before to add two numbers
let's do that and we're going to put in
our requires close and we're going to
require now to support the multipliable
concept and we're going to specify our
template parameter we have the concept n
so we can use that to do whatever we
want now we're going to say t
add and we're going to say t a and t b
and we're going to return a plus b this
is the same function we've been using
all along okay now we have our concept
in place and we have a function template
that is going to use this concept
let's see if we can add up x and y and
see what we get we're going to world
with gcc we're going to see that the
world is going to be good because our
concept here is satisfied we are passing
double types for our function template
and it is legal to multiply two double
variables if we multiply two doubles
we're going to get a value and that's
going to be valid c plus plus syntax but
let's see what happens if we try to
change our arguments to hdd strength
let's do that so we're going to say x is
hello and we're going to say why is
world why not let's go down and put in a
semicolon and the moment we do that you
see that we have a problem and visual
studio code is not good at this yet
but if we go inside
and run this through gcc we're going to
get that our concept is violated let's
look at the compiler error here it's
going to say constraints not satisfied
and it's going to tell us that we are
calling the add function with the values
that can't be multiplied it's going to
say the required expression here is
invalid and this is how you can set up a
concept like this and you can really use
this to
put constraints however you want on your
function templates but here we have just
used one statement inside our concept
here we can even put in more so to drive
this home we're going to set up another
concept let's go down and put that in
place the concept is going to be called
incremental it's going to be using the
same syntax we saw here but we're going
to be putting a requirement on the
template parameter here to support
incrementation and we want for every
type that goes in the place of t here we
must be able to say a plus equals one
this must be valid c plus plus syntax we
must be able to say plus plus a this
must be valid c plus plus syntax and we
must be able to say a plus plus this
must be valid c plus plus syntax
now that we have this we can change our
add function to use this concept why not
we're going to say incrementable and now
this function is going to be required to
use things that we can increment on and
you see it is failing already because we
can't really increment strengths what
does that even mean so let's build and
show you the compiler error okay you see
incremental is not satisfied and that
the required expressions aren't valid
you see plus plus a is not valid a plus
plus is not valid and a plus equals one
should not also be valid but we're not
seeing that here but hopefully you see
the message here that our concept is
failing here if we comment out our
strengths here and uncomment double all
these operations we have here are
supported for the double type
so we should not fail here if we try to
compile this because the concept is
going to be satisfied
let's use the gcc
compiler to build you see the build is
good now
and we can clear and we can bring up a
terminal to really see this that our
binary was generated let's do the ir
we're going to see our rooster
executable here and if we go down let's
say done we're going to see that if we
build again to bring this in
consideration clear run rooster the
program was generated and it is really
running because the concept here
is satisfied
with our call using double arguments
here okay so this is really all i set
out to share with you guys in this
lecture i hope you know the syntaxes you
can use to create your own concepts you
can either use type traits like we have
seen here and the syntax is to put the
keyword concept put in your concept name
put an ecosign and then specify your
type trait here this is going to work if
you need something a little more
complicated then you're going to use
this syntax here and put the
requirements for your concept in these
curly braces you can either put one
statement like we did here or you can
even put as many statements as you want
just remember to end them with
semicolons and another thing you
shouldn't really take lightly is that
this is just going to check for syntax
it's not going to check for the value
you get after you add one to a here for
example it's not going to check for the
value you get after you multiply b it's
just going to see that a multiply b
is valid syntax for the types that our
template parameter is using here we are
going to stop here in this lecture this
one we're going to zoom in a little more
on the requires close here go ahead and
finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to learn about some more things we
can do with our requires close but
before we do that let's look at the
kinds of requirements we can put in our
requires close the first one is a simple
requirement which is what we have seen
so far we can also do a nested
requirement and we're going to learn
about this in a minute and we can do a
compound requirement which is going to
allow us to specify more things about
what we require for our concept there
are also type requirements but these are
really advanced for the scope of this
course so we're not going to talk about
these in this course what we're going to
look at are these three first here so
let's look at a simple requirement this
is what we have seen already here we
have our template declaration we have a
concept declared the concept name is
tiny type we're going to put in our
requires close we're going to put in our
parameter list and we're going to put in
our curly braces inside the requires
close we have a statement here which is
going to enforce that size of t is less
than 4.
and what this really means it's going to
check that size of t the syntax here is
correct and this can really throw people
off i have said this in the last lecture
but i set up this little example to
really drive this home and show you that
if you are not careful your concepts are
going to be really wrong this is going
to check for the syntax so for example
if we call a function template with this
concept with a car type
the concept is going to be satisfied
even if the size of the car is less than
4 obviously but that's not going to be
the job of this concept here this
concept is not going to enforce for the
expression here to evaluate to true it's
going to just check the syntax and if
you pass something smaller than a net in
a function template with this concept
this is going to be valid c plus plus
syntax so the concept is going to work
so now you must be asking how can i
enforce for the value of this expression
to be true
using concept well for that you will
have to use nested requirements and a
nested requirement is going to have
another requires keyword inserted in
front of it now if you use the syntax
like this now this is going to check
that size of t is actually less than 4.
if it's not less than 4 this is going to
return false here and the concept is
going to fail and this is how you can
use nested requirements to enforce for
some expressions to be true in your
requires close another kind of
requirement you can set up for your
concept is the compound requirement and
this is going to allow you to check if
something doesn't throw an exception you
can do that using the no accept keyword
but we're not going to use this now
because this is not in scope for what we
can do at this point in the course but
you can also check the return type of an
expression and divorce that it satisfies
some type trait for example so here we
are saying for our concept and if we
pass in two parameters the syntax for
adding a and b must be correct and
supported for those types but the result
of a and b must also be convertible to
ant and you can do something like this
and this is going to work you can
enforce these kinds of things using
compound requirements okay now that you
know about these kinds of requirements
you can put in your requires close let's
head over to visual studio code and play
with us a little more okay here we are
in our working folder the current
project is zooming in on requires close
we're going to grab our template files
and we're going to put them in place and
we're going to open that in visual
studio code pretty quick by dragging and
dropping here this is going to open up
our folder we're going to do the usual
we're going to close the pane here we're
going to clean things up a little bit
and we're going to include our concepts
library let's do that we are going to
set up a simple concept we're going to
say template and we're going to say what
the concept is the concept is going to
be called the tiny type and we're going
to say
what makes this concept a tiny time
we're going to put in our requires close
and we're going to put in the template
parameter call it t why not and we're
going to put in our closing semicolon
here now what is going to make this
concept a tiny type is that the size of
the template parameter view is going to
be less than four let's suppose we are
doing the function and we wanted to use
for
integral types that are smaller than
four bytes in memory suppose you want to
do this and it is useful
in the problem that you are trying to
solve in c plus plus the way we can
enforce this we can say size of t is
supposed to be less than four let's say
size of properly can't type can i okay
the moment we do this you're going to
see that this is valid c plus plus
syntax so we're not going to have any
squiggly lines but what you should know
is that this is a simple requirement in
c plus plus concepts and what this is
going to do
it's just going to enforce the syntax of
what we do here what we put here must be
valid c plus plus syntax so only
enforces syntax this is what you should
really remember okay now that we have
this end let's try it out and show you
some problems you can really run into
we're going to set up two character
variables we're going to call the first
one x we're going to initialize this
with 57 why not 67 and we're going to
put in the other variable which is going
to be y and it's going to have a 56 n
you can put in whatever you want just
make sure that you are within the range
of the card type which is between 0 and
255 if you remember okay now that we
have this n i realize we don't have a
function we can try this on let's set up
another function pretty quick we're
going to say tiny type auto we can do
that you already know this syntax and
we're going to say add tiny type auto a
and a tiny type auto p we can do that
and we're going to return a plus b now
that we have this let's say a and b down
here and call this function we're going
to say x and y and we're going to try
and compile this program and it is going
to compile fine because the type we are
using to call the function which is car
its size is going to be less than four
okay so this is going to work and it is
going to compile
let's build with gcc you're going to see
that the build is good let's try and uh
change the type here to end or even
double you know double is 8 bytes in
memory so we expect this to probably
give us something wrong double type is
eight bytes in memory so we expect the
size of t here
to be false because the size of t is
going to be eight and eight is not less
than four this is going to be false so
some might expect this concept here to
fail
but let's try and really prove you wrong
we're going to build with gcc and you
see it's building successfully what this
is really doing is that with simple
requirements like we have here c plus
plus is only going to enforce for this
to be valid c plus plus syntax and size
of t is less than four
is going to be valid c plus plus syntax
even if this expression here evaluates
to false this is not going to enforce
for the value of this expression to be
false you can't do that with simple
requirements what you will do is check
that this is valid syntax now what do we
do if we really want to enforce that
size of t should be
less than four if you want that you
should use nested requirements and the
syntax to do that is really simple we
can go down here and put that in we're
going to say requires we're going to add
a requires keyword in front of this then
we're going to put our expression here
let's copy it and put it in i don't want
to type this again the moment we do this
now compilation is going to fail if we
pass a type whose size is not less than
four
and let's try and build again you're
going to see that the world is going to
fail now and we're going to have a
failed concept and you see world
finished with errors we have constraints
not satisfied and if we go down here
we're going to see required for the
satisfaction of tiny type auto and we
passed in a double type whose size is 8
bytes in memory and it is less than four
bytes you see the requirement here it is
not satisfied we can do this using
nested requirements okay if we go down
for example and change this to car some
people call this char but i call this
car that's my habit if we change this to
car
and try to bolt again you're going to
see that it is going to weld fine
because now what is wrong here let's see
what we got wrong huh we are getting a
compiler error here what is the problem
it's going to say
let's go up and try to analyze this a
little bit it's saying deduce the return
type does not satisfy placeholder
constraints
and we are requiring for the return type
of this guy to be tiny time uh-huh i
think i know what the problem is the
problem is the arithmetic operations
like the addition we're doing here are
not supported for types which are
smaller than ant and is the smallest
type we can use with arithmetic
operations so what the compiler is going
to do is going to do implicit
conversions from car to end and inside
here what we will have are going to be
ant the result of this is going to be
ant and the return type is going to be
deduced to be at but ant
is going to violate the requirement we
have here which is saying that the size
of tiny type here should be less than
four and the return of ant is not less
than four so we can try and fix this by
putting an equal sign here and i think
it's going to work let's do that and
world again this is a good learning
experience and now you see that the
build is going to work because now the
return type is going to satisfy our
requirements so let's prove that we are
getting a net out of this actually we're
going to do our own result and we're
going to say equal and grab the result
of this guy we should really prove these
thanks and after this we're going to
print the results we can do that and we
can even go further and print the size
of result here so we're going to say
size of result okay now that we have
this end we can weld with gcc and the
world is good don't mind this squiggly
line it is probably visual studio code
messing with us you see that the world
is good we can now bring up a terminal
and run this and see the size of the
return type and really prove
that the compiler turned that into an
end even if we called our function with
car arguments this is interesting so
clear and run rooster now we're going to
see results is going to be 123 and the
size of the result is for even if we
passed in car types as our arguments
okay so hopefully this proves that you
can set up nested requirements to
enforce for the expression here to be
checked another type of requirement you
can do is a compound requirement let's
put this in and we're going to put in a
simple example to drive this home i
think i should take this function and
put that below our concepts so a
compound requirement looks like this you
put your expression in acrylics like
this and then you can even put
requirements on the values of the
expression for example we can enforce
that the value of a plus b here should
be convertible to and if it's not
convertible to end the concept here is
going to fail this is a compound
requirement you can even put no except
keywords in here but we're not going to
go this far because we haven't really
learned about exceptions so for now i'm
going to test this out i just wanted you
to be aware that you can do that now
that we have this concept n let's play
with it and see how we can make it break
thanks we're going to change our concept
to edible let's say edible here and
we're going to say edible and we're
going to
put in our car types here and it is
going to slay work because
we can add two car variables and this is
going to work because we can add two car
variables and this is valid syntax what
we're going to get out of that is going
to be an ant because remember the
compiler is going to insert implicit
conversions from card to end because it
can't really add two card types and is
the smallest thing you can do arithmetic
operations on so the result of this is
going to be an end so a lens is
convertible to an edge this is going to
work let's build and show you that this
is going to work we're going to weld
this with the gcc you see build is good
we can try and run this and see what we
get after calling the function we get
result is 123 and this is going to be
the size of four because we get a net
out of this let's try and change this to
double and see what we get so double
let's say double here and if we would we
expect this to work because adding up
two doubles is going to give you a
double
and we're going to return a double from
this function
and uh a double is convertible to a net
so we're going to return a double from
this guy and this should say eight now
because that's what we are returning
from the function here let's build with
gcc you see the both is good we can
clear and run rooster this is going to
say size of result is eight because now
what we are returning is going to be a
double from this function here and
double satisfies our concept adding up
two doubles is valid syntax and what we
get out of that is going to be a double
and a double is convertible to a net
this is going to work let's try and
change our parameters here to strength
we're going to comment out our x and y
variables here and we're going to set up
two strings going to say std string x
and we're going to say hello and you
know what we're going to say and why
we're going to say std strength y
and we're going to say world why not and
the moment we do this you see that we
have a problem why do we have a problem
because it is now a requirement for the
result of a and b to be convertible to
end remember that you can add up two
strands for example you can say auto s
and say x plus y this is going to work
because you can add up two strings and
this is going to concatenate them so
this is valid syntax why are we failing
here because we have a requirement for
this to be convertible to an end and the
strength isn't really convertible to an
end so this is going to fail let's build
this program and show you that this is
actually the case we're going to see
world finished with arrows and let's see
the error we have okay so constraints
not satisfied it's going to say required
the satisfaction of audible with auto
here in requirement and it's going to
say
a plus b does not satisfy the type
requirement because what we get after
adding a and b is not convertible to an
end and you see that here
a plus b convertible to an end this is
going to fail okay so let's try and
remove this requirement to convert to
end and see that this actually works
we're going to remove this i'm going to
cut this out
and try to build again i am going to use
gcc to build and now you see that this
is welding because we no longer
have the requirement of the return value
of this expression or result i should
say the result of this function
now doesn't have to be convertible to an
okay let's put this back because i want
you to see this later as a reference and
now you know how you can use compound
requirements to really put constraints
on your function templates this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
i think i should comment out these guys
because i don't like to leave you with
code that has compiler errors let's turn
this back to double so that this works
we're going to weld again okay the world
is good and we are going to stop here in
this lecture in the next one we're going
to see how we can combine concepts and
do some crazy things
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to see
how we can combine concepts using
logical operators we can combine
concepts using the and operator and the
r operator as you see here let's look at
a simple example here we have a concept
it is time type we have seen before and
it's going to check that the size of the
template parameter we pass is less than
four it's going to enforce the syntax
with a simple requirement but it's also
going to enforce for the value of this
expression to be true if the value is
not true the concept is going to fail
and we are using a nested requirement
for this so this is our concept here
let's try and set up a function and see
how we can combine this concept with
other concepts here we have a function
it is going to return a t the name of
the function is func it is taking in our
parameter and here we have the body of
the function within these two curly
braces but what we have here is a
concept we want to apply to this
function here and the first line here is
going to show that we can combine the
concept
like we do here so this entire thing is
going to be a logical combination of
concepts so we can require that the
template parameter be either an integral
type or a floating point type using the
or operator here another thing we can do
is use the and operator as you see down
here in the second line and we're going
to require that
the
template parameter is both integral and
a tiny type and the compiler is going to
enforce these things as we are about to
see in a minute when we hit visual
studio code you can even specify your
concepts in place for example the third
line here is going to say we require for
the concept to be integral so it should
be an integral type and we're going to
specify our tiny type concept in place
you see we are doing that right here in
the function declaration and this is
going to work this is a valid c plus
plus syntax but i don't recommend this
because this is going to make your
function declarations really ugly so now
that you know this we're going to head
over to visual studio code and play with
this a little more it's just using the
or and and operator to combine concepts
okay here we are in our working folder
the current project is combining
concepts we're going to grab our
template files pretty quick and put them
in place and we're going to open this in
visual studio code as we always do by
dragging and dropping here we have our
file we're going to open that up and
close the left pane here i don't like it
and we're going to include our concepts
library let's do that we have this and
the first thing we're going to do is to
put in our tiny type concept here so it
is tiny type it's going to require that
the syntax for the size of t less than
4b supported this is a simple
requirement again and we're going to
require that this expression be true and
we're doing this
using a nested requirement okay now that
we have this concept we can combine this
with other concepts let's use the same
function we've been using all along so
we're going to say template type name
team and we're going to put in our
requires clause so we're going to say
requires we can use std intergroup and
say t
and say or it should be htd floating
point i think we have this end this is a
concept we have which is built into the
c plus plus standard library we can use
this now that we have this we can then
say the signature of a function t x is
going to add up t a and t b and it's
going to return the sum of a and b now
you can only call this function with
either integers or floating points if
you try to deviate from this the concept
is going to fail and we're going to get
a compiler error let's go down and try
this out we're going to say and x and
put in a 6 for example and into y and
put in a 4 and we're going to add this
up we're going to say add x and y and if
we do this this is going to work because
this is an integer so the concept here
is going to succeed let's weld with gcc
and show you that the build is good the
world is good so no problem we can
change this to double it is going to
work because double is a floating point
let's say double properly and if we blow
it again the bullet is going to go
through but if we try and use for
example a strength let's say std
strength string that's a strength and
we're going to change this into double
quotes we can do that and say std
strength and i put this in quotes again
double quotes okay if we do this you see
we have a squiggly line and if we walk
we're going to have violated our concept
because the parameters that we pass
don't satisfy this concept it's neither
an integral type or a floating point
type and if we go up here we're going to
see that we have violated a concept
constraint not satisfied and it's going
to say the concept that was not
satisfied here which is right here okay
you can combine two concepts using the
or operator but we can also use the and
operator
let's go down and try and put up a
simple example that is going to do that
now what we're going to require for
people to use this function is to
satisfy
both tiny type and integral so we're
going to say requires std integral i
think we have this n and we're going to
say and
tiny time and we're going to say our
template parameter here the moment we do
this and let's turn this back to being
at let's say ant x and put in a seven
what we had before and at y and let's
say four or a five doesn't matter
if we do this
let's see our thing again so tiny type
requires for the size to be less or
equal
to four so ant is going to work this is
going to build because the concept is
going to be satisfied it is both
integral and tiny type
let's work and see this run you see the
world is good our concept is satisfied
but the moment we try and use something
that is greater than four
we're going to have a problem
let's use a double for example we're
going to change this to double and world
we expect compilation to fail because
the type which is double doesn't satisfy
the tiny type concept and we're going to
see that here okay so we're going to see
weld finished with arrows and we're
going to have a lengthy error here but
the meat of this is that we have a
constraint which is not satisfied
and it is
that for required for the satisfaction
of std integral so double is not going
to satisfy this i think double was a
really bad example because it's not
integral so integral is going to fail
what if we pass in long ant okay which
is really
an integral type but it's not going to
satisfy tiny type so let's say long end
and we're going to build now we are
going to violate let's use long long ant
because i think long end is not large
enough so we're going to build now we're
going to fail because tiny type is not
satisfied you see required for a
dissatisfaction of tiny type and it's
going to say size of t is less than 4 is
not satisfied because guess what the
size of lung lung ant is greater than 4.
you can try and prove that by taking out
this guy here and saying stdc out size
of a long long end we're going to see
this print out
and if we're boiled now we're not going
to violate our concepts because we're
not calling the function
the word is going to be good what we
want to do is run the program and see
the size of lung lung ant we can do this
rooster eight the size of lung lung ant
is eight and it is going to violate our
tiny type concept okay you can do things
like this and combine the concepts but
we can even put our concepts in place we
can do something crazy and for example
say let's copy this and we're going to
go down and say requires integral but
we're going to put timely type in place
for example we're going to grab the
requires close here and copy it
and put that in place of tiny type here
we're going to do this
and you're going to see that this is
going to be valid c plus plus syntax if
we take out the semicolon because it
shouldn't be there but look at this this
is really ugly this is going to make
your functions really hard to read but
it is going to work exactly the same way
it did if we call this function we're
going to violate tiny type let's do that
we're going to build with gcc we have an
error let's bring this up so that we can
see what is wrong nested requirement
size of t is not satisfied this is a
syntax you can use but i don't really
recommend this because this is going to
make you code hard to read and this is
really all we set out to do in this
lecture looking at how we can combine
our concepts using the and operator and
the or operator and you can really use
this in all the syntaxes for concepts we
have seen but i just used this in this
lecture because it is simpler to show
we are going to stop here in this
lecture the next one we're going to look
at concepts and auto go ahead and finish
up here and meet me there in this
lecture we're going to zoom in on
concepts and the auto key world we have
already seen that we can do something
like this use the auto keywords with our
functions and let the compiler generate
a function template behind the scenes
and this worked pretty well we could use
this syntax to put constraints on our
other keywords and we saw that the
compiler could actually enforce this and
throw a compiler error if our concept
here is violated what i haven't shown
you is that you can even enforce
concepts on variables that you declare
you can do something like this set up a
variable say auto x and call the
variable x and enforce for the variable
to be an integral type i don't really
think you have much use for this because
once you call the function and assign a
value to a variable you already have an
idea of what is going to come out of the
function but if you have a use case for
something like this please go ahead and
use this it is going to enforce your
concepts you can even use concepts like
this set up a variable and assign a
literal to the variable name using the
auto keyword here but i personally find
this useless because you are putting in
the value yourself
why do you want to put a protection if
you know that you are putting in a
double literal then the variable should
be a double type i find this a little
bit useless but it is supported in c
plus plus if you have a use case for
this please go ahead and use this now
that you know this we're going to head
over to visual studio code and play with
us a little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
concepts and auto we're going to grab
our template files and we're going to
put them in place and we're going to
open this up in visual studio code let's
do that pretty quick we're going to have
our folder open we're going to open the
main cpp file close the left pane and
clean things up a little bit and we're
going to include our concepts library
and we're going to put in our function
which is going to be using the auto
keywords to
really make the syntax nice and cool but
we're going to be constraining our auto
parameters here to use integral types if
we call this function with something
that is not an integer or any trigger
type really we're going to get a
compiler error so if we go down here for
example and say add and say
10.9 and 0.1 we're going to get a
compiler error because 10.9 and 0.1 are
double literals and we only support
integral types in this function here so
let's work and show you the error but
you must know this by now because we
have done this like a gazillion times
the concept integral is going to be
violated and it's going to say required
for the satisfaction of integral so the
concept is failing here we're going to
get a compiler error but if we change
this for example to 10 and 5 put in
whatever you want which is an integer
this is going to work we're going to
build with gcc
you see the wealth is good so you can
use auto with concepts like this we have
seen this syntax already a couple of
times in this chapter what we haven't
seen is that for example you can set up
a variable in main and call this x y
naught and say this variable should
satisfy the concept and specify the
concept you want for example let's say
std integral and if you do something
like this let's see what we get from
this we're going to world you see the
work is good because if we add up these
guys we're going to generate an integer
instance for this function and we're
going to deduce the return type as ant
so the return type is going to be
integral and it's going to be assignable
in our variable here but if we change to
floating point i think we have this
concept in place yes we do but it is
going to fail because what we get from
this function is going to be an integer
and we can't assign to this because this
concept here is saying
what you try to assign to this variable
here should be a floating point this is
the meaning here and if we do this we're
going to get to the error probably so we
have the arrow and it's going to say
constraint not satisfied and it is going
to say the
constraint we didn't satisfy which is
its floating point here this is how you
can put constraints on your variables
even when you are declaring them so
another thing we can try here is to
assign
a literal to this variable here let's
put in a 3.9 and see if this actually
boils and compiles
let's build with gcc
you see the build is good and the
requirement is for what we assigned to
this variable here should be a double
and a 3.9 is already a double so no
problem but if we try and make this
seven for example
this is going to fail so let's build
again you see the concept is going to
fail and this is how you can use these
things to constrain your variables i
personally find this a little bit
useless at least in this case here
because i know that i have an integer
literal
and i am assigning this to a variable
why do i need the help of concepts to
really
constrain my variable here but in the
case where you are calling a function
for example using a 5 and an 8
this can come in handy because it's not
easy to keep track of the return type
you get from a function because the
function might have a return expression
that has multiple different variables
and it's not easy to keep track of what
you get back from a function and you can
use a constraint like this to make sure
what you get from the function is what
you want and if it's not what you want
you're going to throw a compiler error
because the concept you use is going to
fail i would like to welcome you in this
new chapter where we're going to be
learning about classes classes are a
mechanism we have in c plus plus to
build our own types and use them like we
have been using other bulletin types
like and to double or whatever and we're
going to be able to do that by setting
up blueprints of our class types and
we're going to be using those blueprints
to build actual objects that we can use
in our c plus plus program so for
example we can have a class as a
blueprint and we can create real class
objects in our c plus plus program as we
need them and we're going to be learning
all about this in the next few chapters
we are going to head over in the next
lecture and let you set up your very
first c plus plus class go ahead and
finish up here and meet me there in this
lecture you are going to build your
first c plus plus class classes are a
mechanism we have in c plus plus to be
able to build our own types if you
remember so far in this course we have
been using basic types like ant and
double
and we were using them like this we said
the type of the variable we give the
name of the variable and then we
initialize this variable and we can use
this throughout our program now we are
at a point where we need to start
designing our own types suppose we want
to build our own type that models a
person for example suppose a person is
defined by the name
the age and the address and we want to
model persons in our program
and use them as players for example and
when we have the properties of a person
we can do all kinds of crazy things with
them we can make them jump up for
example if we are designing a game we
can make them run we can make them fly
we can do all kinds of crazy things in
this lecture we're going to use a
cylinder as an example and we're going
to model a cylinder in our c plus plus
program a cylinder is defined by two
things it has a base radius which is
modeled by this r you see here and it
has a height
and when we have this information about
our cylinder we can really do all kinds
of crazy things for example we can
compute its area the base area and the
formula to do that is pi
r squared this is a formula you get from
your basic mathematics education
you can compute the volume of the
cylinder and the formula to do that is
area multiplied by the height and we can
really do all kinds of crazy things with
the cylinder if we have this information
so we're going to use this information
and model a cylinder we can use in our c
plus plus program and we're going to be
using classes to do that the syntax to
set up your class in c plus plus it's
really simple you say class this is the
keyword you have to put in here you say
the name of your class in this case it
is cylander as you see here and then we
put a pair of curly braces in place the
start is on top here and the end is down
here and after your class definition
you're going to put a semicolon inside
the class we really have two parts we
have member variables which are going to
model the properties that your class is
going to have in this case we have two
properties that really define a cylinder
we have the best radius and we have the
height we have decided to model these
things as double types inside our class
and this is going to make the first part
of our class the member variables the
second part is going to be made of
behaviors or functions that do things on
the class using the properties and one
function we have is the volume function
which is going to help us compute the
volume of our cylinder here if you look
at its syntax it really is a function we
have a return type we have the name of
the function we have the parameter list
which is empty by now and we have our
curly braces that delimit the body of
our function inside the function we're
going to do nothing special we're just
going to return the volume of our
function here and if you remember the
volume is the base area
multiplied by the height and this thing
here is going to model the base area you
see it's pi
multiplied by the square of the radius
and then we're going to multiply this by
the height and we're going to return the
volume for use by whoever is calling
this function
one thing we haven't really talked about
is this public thing you see here
and what this says is that the members
that we have in this class are going to
be accessible from the outside of the
class for now we can't really understand
this but when we hit visual studio code
i'm going to show you what this exactly
means
now that we have the class declared we
can really use it like we use any other
types in c plus plus for example we can
head in our main function
and set up a variable called cylinder
one as you see here is type is going to
be cylinder and notice that this is
really a type that we build ourselves
and we can really use it like we use
other variables for example we can call
it function using the syntax here and
print the volume this is going to print
the volume using the volume function
that we just set up in a minute if we go
down we can modify things about our
cylinder for example we can use the dot
notation here to change the base radius
and change the height and if we try to
print the volume again this information
is going to be picked up and be used by
the volume function to compute the
volume of our cylinder here this is
really cool if you want you can also set
up another cylinder like we do here and
we're going to print the volume and we
can really do all kinds of crazy things
with our types like this okay this is
our class and we can really use it to do
a lot before we head over to visual
studio code and play with us i want to
bring to your attention that members of
a class
are private by default and what i mean
by that is that for example if we don't
put this public keywords in here we want
to be able
to use the volume function for example
like we have used it in our main
function as you see here
if the member is private it won't be
usable outside the class this is what we
mean here we are trying to use this
member in the main function
outside the class definition it won't be
accessible if it is private and we make
it public by putting the public keyword
and the column like we do here
everything after this public keyword is
going to be public until we change this
to private somewhere in our program if
we need that now that you have an idea
about how you can declare and use your
class in c plus plus let's head over to
visual studio code and play with us a
little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
your first class you are going to build
your very first class in c plus plus
we're going to grab our template files
we're going to copy them and put them in
place and then we're going to open this
little guy in visual studio code by
dragging and dropping here this is going
to open our folder we're going to close
the left pane here and clean things up a
little bit the first thing we want to do
is to declare our class
but before we do that we're going to
need the pi variable because remember
we're going to model pi
for use in computing the area and the
volume of our cylinder that we want to
model like we did in the slides so the
way we're going to do that i am going to
declare a const variable and i am going
to call it pi
and i am going to initialize this with
pi to get pi i'm going to cheat a little
bit i'm going to go in my calculator and
let's see if i can get pi here and i
click on this and i'm going to grab pi
here and copy it this is the easiest way
i can find so i'm going to put it in
here and this is going to be our
variable now that we have this we're
going to set up our class and that to
define a class you say class you have to
put in this keyword and then we're going
to say the name of the class the name of
the class is going to be cylinder and
after we do this we're going to put a
pair of curly braces and we're going to
end this with a semi-colon you have to
remember this if you don't put it here
the ziploc plus compiler is going to
complain
now that we have the class blueprint
here we're going to put in our member
variable and these are going to be the
variables we use to model the base
radius and the height of our cylinder
we're going to put in a double variable
and we're going to call this base radius
and we're going to brace initialize this
to zero we can do this and we're going
to set up another one and call it height
and we're going to also initialize this
to zero okay now that we have this we're
going to put functions or methods in our
class and we do that by just putting the
function definition in our class so our
function is going to be returning double
because it's going to be returning the
volume
of our cylinder so it's going to return
double here the name is going to be
volume and it's going to be computing
the volume and returning that remember
the formula to compute the volume
is going to be pi we have a pi variable
on top and we're going to multiply by
this radius twice because the base
radius has to be squared let's do that
and multiply by base radius again and
then we're going to multiply by height
and notice that these are guys declared
in the body of the class if i can say
that this is the definition of the class
we are able to use this guys because we
are inside this class here okay now that
we have this our class is really defined
but we can't really use it quite yet
what do i mean by that let's go in the
main function and we're going to set up
a variable of type cylinder we can do
that and let's call this cylinder one if
we do this and try to compile this this
is going to work fine let's do that
we're going to
world with gcc
world finished successfully this is
welding but we have a function called
volume here and we can try and call it
using the dot notation that we saw in
the slides let's try and print the
volume of our cylinder here and see what
we get so we're going to say volume we
can save that and we're going to say
cylinder one and do volume okay let's
see if we can call this function here
and the moment we do that you see that
we have a squiggly line here so visual
studio code has detected that something
is wrong let's hit the problems tab here
and see what we get it's going to say
expected an identifier on line what this
is not making sense
uh we put three columns here let's
correct this a little bit
and the error is going to change to be
suddenly the volume declared at line 6
is inaccessible from this location here
this is what the error says and it is
not sensible
because members of the class are private
by default so they want to be accessible
from the outside of the class like we
are doing in the main function here
notice that we are able to access them
from the inside of the class you see
base radius is declared down here and we
are able to use in the function because
the function volume here is inside the
class so the members are accessible even
if they are private but private members
can't be accessible from the outside of
the class like we are doing in the main
function here that's why we have this
problem let's see what the compiler says
we're going to pass this through gcc and
we're going to get a compiler error that
we expect and the compiler is really
specific on this it's going to say
double cylinder volume the volume
function from the cylinder class is
private within this context and which
context the line 19 when we are trying
to use it in the main function so if you
really want thanks inside the class to
be accessible from the outside you need
to make them public and change them from
private how do we do that it is really
simple you use the syntax we saw in the
slides we're going to say public and put
a column here and when you do this it is
advised to align your things a little
bit properly so when we do this
everything after this public keyword is
going to be public in this class and it
will be accessible from the outside
let's try and build now but before we
build let's show you that the squiggly
line should be gone visual studio code
is still confused let's try and vault
let's pass this through gcc now you see
that the world is good okay now if you
try and print the volume here we're
going to get zero because the base
radius is braced initialized to zero the
height is zero and if we multiply like
this we're going to get a zero and
return that let's try and run this
program because we just build it
successfully we can bring up a terminal
to do that and let's clear and run
rooster and we can see that the volume
is zero and it is what we expect okay
now our class is working but there is
really something bad about it and
that is because the public keyword is
going to make everything public in this
class the member variables are also
going to be public so we can go down
here and print the base radius and the
height for example let's do that and
show you that this is the case so we're
going to say cylinder one and say base
radius this is going to print and we're
going to say hi we're going to print
this out if we try and print these guys
let's build and pass this through gcc
you see the bolt is good and if we clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
this radius and height are or accessible
to show you that this can also be
different from zero let's change the
base radius to one and the height to one
to make it a unit cylinder let's try and
weld we're going to change these guys to
one and the volume is going to be
3.14 or something let's run rooster
we're going to see our volume here and
we have the base radius and the height
but this is really bad design because
the member variables
in most cases you're going to want to
keep them private from the outside
because users of your class don't really
care about the member variables they
just want to do things with your class
for example calling the volume function
here so what we usually do in
practice is to flag our member variables
as private and we can do that using the
private keyword as we do here and at the
moment we do this everything after this
private keyword is going to be private
to the class it is only going to be
accessible from the inside of the class
but if we try to access that from the
outside we're going to get the same
compiler error we saw before when we
tried to access private stuff from the
class in the main function here visual
studio code is going to give us a
problem saying that these member
variables are not accessible from this
context here and if we pass this through
gcc we're going to get a clear compiler
error saying that the height
and the
base radius are now private in the class
and we can't access them from the
outside this is really what i wanted you
to see and this is good design okay now
that we have our class declared and that
we can use it in the main function i
want you to see that it is possible to
change these member variables but to do
that we will need to turn this back to
public and we're going to see a better
way to do this later but for now let's
make them public and show you that we
can change things around and make our
cylinders a little more interesting so
now that they are public we can go in
the main function and do crazy things
change the data for example we can
change our member variables to be
something else let's go down and say
cylinder one and say base radius we can
use the dot notation and put an ecosign
and give another value to our base
radius let's make it 10 for example and
change the height to be something else
we can change that and we're going to
put in a 3 for example why not now if we
print the volume again we're going to
get another value let's copy this and
put that down below
our changes here and if we build the
program it should well define the world
is good
so we can hit enter and clear and if we
run rooster we're going to get
the volume to be
3.14 first here the first line here and
the second line is going to give us
another volume and if we multiply these
guys with pi
and if we use our formula to compute the
volume we're going to basically get the
same thing let's try and prove this with
our calculator we have it around so we
have pi in here we're going to multiply
this with
100 which is
the radius squared we're going to put
100 here and we're going to multiply
this with 3 which is our height let's
put this in and we have
942.47 which is what we have here
roughly the same thing so you see that
our function is really computing our
volume we can even go down and change
the height to something else for example
we're going to change the height to
let's make an eight and i printed the
volume again you can keep playing with
us and really make it clear
that our volume function is computing
our volume using the data that we have
in the member variables this is the
message here let's build again the world
should be good we're going to clear and
run rooster now we see another
number for our volume and this is really
how you can declare a class again you
use the syntax you see here class you
say the class name you put a pair of
curly braces and you put your semicolon
don't forget this
members of your class are private by
default but you can make them public if
you want using the public keyword as we
did here inside your class you're going
to have two parts you're going to have
the member variables which are going to
be properties that define what your
class is and we're going to have
functions or methods let's say that and
these are going to be behaviors
of your class you're going to go through
these functions to make your classes do
things and once you have the class
definition in place you can use it to
create
variables as we do in the main function
here and the variables we create from
our class are usually called objects in
c plus plus terminology okay the class
is really a blueprint and we create
objects using that blueprint and objects
are going to have runtime data that we
store in our class okay so for example
if we hit this point here the base
radius is going to be 10 and the height
is going to be eight and that's going to
be runtime information for our class
object stored in this variable that we
call cylinder one here this is really
what i wanted you to see okay let's try
and recap what we know about classes so
far a class can have member variables
but so far we have used member variables
as stack variables if we go back for
example you see that we say base radius
here you notice it is not a pointer or a
reference or anything it is a stack
variable inside our class so member
variables can only be stack variables
like we have here but they can also be
pointers but they can never be
references and the reason is a reference
can never be left uninitialized and in
the classes when we declare member
variables the ability to leave them
uninitialized is really important and we
can't really do that with references i
can't really go into the details of that
as we will see that as we progress in
the chapter but know that member
variables can either be stacked
variables or pointers but they can never
be references in z plus okay that's what
we just said here members can't be
references classes can have functions or
methods that let them do things we saw
an example of this with our volume
function class methods have access to
the member variables regardless of
whether they are public or private we
have seen that the volume function will
have access to our member variables
regardless of whether it is public or
private and last but not least private
members of classes aren't accessible
from the outside as we saw in the main
function you can't access them from the
main function you can only do that from
the class definition itself this is
really all i had to share in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this one in
the next one we're going to see how
class objects are built
from constructors go ahead and finish up
here and meet me there in this lecture
we're going to learn about constructors
and constructors are special class
methods or functions
that are called by the compiler to
construct your class objects and they
are special because they have no return
type a constructor can never have a
return type as you see here they have
the same name as the class so for
example for our class in the last
lecture that was called silenter the
constructors are also going to have the
same name as the class they are going to
be called also slander constructors can
have parameters but if it makes sense
for whatever it is you are trying to do
you can also leave the parameters out
and constructors are usually used to
initialize the member variables and put
them in a state where you want them in
your c plus plus application
let's look at how you can declare
constructors for your classes
here is our cylinder class you see we
have our member variables we had they
are private now and we have
a public section which is going to have
our functions or behaviors as you see
here the member variables are what we
have seen from the last lecture but if
you look here we have a few new things
here
we have two things that look like
functions but they don't have return
values that's something you should
notice
they have a parameter list as you see
here and we have a pair of curly braces
because these are really functions and
these are special functions that are
going to be called by the compiler to
initialize your class objects if you
look here in this example we are
using the
constructor with no parameters to
initialize our member variables to 2 and
we have another constructor as you see
down here which is going to take
parameters directly and it's going to
take the radius parameter and the height
parameter the parameters are of double
type because that's what we expect in
our class and we are passing them by
value here because they are fundamental
types and we don't really mind copying
them but please keep in mind that they
are going to be passed by value and what
you have inside your constructor body
are going to be copies of the original
arguments that were passed to your
constructor and this is really how you
declare constructors for your c plus
plus classes constructors can either
have parameters like we have again on
this example here or they can have no
parameters and this is going to be a
default constructor we're going to see
that this is going to be called when you
try to create
variables of this cylinder type without
passing the parenthesis like we do when
we call this second constructor here
we're going to see this in a minute okay
this is all i think i have to share in
the slides about how you declare
constructors let's head over to visual
studio code and play with this a little
more okay here we are in our working
folder the current project is
constructors we're going to put in our
template files pretty quick let's do
that and we are going to open this in
visual studio code by dragging and
dropping on top here
this is going to open our folder let's
open our main cpp file
and we're going to take out what we
don't need in the main function and on
top here and i am going to reuse code
from the last lecture because we don't
want to type that again so let's put in
our class definition we have our
variable pi which is going to be used to
compute the volume in the class here and
we have member variables okay now that
we are here let's change the member
variables to be private because making
them public is really going to be bad
design it's going to expose them in the
main function and people can mess with
them and really change the logic of how
our class works without our concept it
is advised to make your member variables
private unless you really have a
compelling reasons to make them public
okay now that we have our class here
let's set up constructors for it so
we're going to go down here in the
public scope and say constructors and
we're going to set up the first
constructor which is not going to take
any parameter so we're going to say the
name of the class remember a constructor
doesn't have a return type and it has to
have the same name as the class so we
need to comply with that and we're going
to put our pair of curly braces and
inside we're going to initialize our
member variables however we want so what
we're going to do here we're going to
set the base radius to something let's
make it a 2 like we saw in the slides no
problem with that and we're going to set
the height to something else and we are
going to set the height to 2 as well we
can do that you can use what you want
and now we have our constructor and it
is initializing our thanks okay now that
we have the constructor in place
how is it really called by the compiler
and notice that our constructor is in
the public scope of the class
if it isn't public you want to be able
to access it from the outside and the
compiler will fail to build your objects
and we're going to see this in a minute
but before we do that let's try and
create a cylinder object now so we're
going to say cylinder and say cylinder
one like we did in the last lecture
and when we do this notice what we see
if we print the volume of our cylinder
object here this is an object because
we're creating this from our blueprint
which is the class definition here you
really need to know this this is a class
object let's say that and we're going to
print its volume we're going to say
cylinder one and we're going to call our
volume method we should say and if we
build you're going to see that this is
going to work but
the volume is not going to be coming
from the initial values we have here we
will have changed these guys to 2
from our constructor here because the
compiler is going to look at this line
here and see that we are trying to build
a silent object it's going to look at
the class definition and it is going to
say do i have any constructor
that i can use to build an object from
the syntax i see here and it's going to
see that it has a constructor that
doesn't take any parameter and it's
going to use it to build our object and
it's going to be using this information
to build our cylinder object so the base
radius is going to be two the height is
going to be two and it's going to use
that to compute the volume
that we print here you really need to
understand this let's vote
and see
if gcc accepts this you see the both is
good now we can bring up a terminal and
clear and run rooster you're going to
see that we have 25 something which is a
result of using this information we have
here if we take pi multiplied by this
base radius multiply by this base radius
again and multiply by height we're going
to get this here you can try this out it
is going to be what you see here and
this hopefully proves that the compiler
is using our constructor here but we can
also use a debugger
let's set up a breakpoint here
and we're going to run this through our
debugger we can come back to the run tab
here
as we have done before
and we're going to try and use the
debugging tools that come
with the gcc compiler that's what we can
use if you are on windows you can also
use the
tools that come with the compiler from
microsoft but we're not going to use
that now gcc is going to be fine we're
going to start the debugging and we
should hit our breakpoint when the build
is done let's wait a minute okay we have
hit our breakpoint
we can minimize this a little bit and i
show the terminal to the right here i
think we can do that let's do that let's
put that a little bit to the right here
and minimize a little bit okay we have
our thunk in place we have hit our break
point you see these are the local
variables we have here we have a
cylinder object which is not initialized
yet because you see what we have inside
is really junk data we haven't put in
anything yet but now that we are at this
break point here we can hit step into
and step into the code that constructs
our cylinder object because at this
point liner 25 here hasn't run yet so
we're going to step into and you're
going to see that we hit the constructor
for our cylinder object
and
this again proves that our constructor
is being used to build our cylinder
objects
now we can move to the next line we're
going to set up the base radius and if
we hit next here this is going to set
our base radius to 2
and you see that height is in one
because we haven't set it up yet but if
we execute this line you're going to see
that height is also going to change to
two
and now if we hit next we're going to
get out of our constructor and our
cylinder object will be already
constructed if we look again here we're
going to see that radius is 2 height is
2 and we can print the volume and if we
hit step over we're going to see our
volume printed out here hopefully again
this proves that our constructor here is
being used to build
objects and it is doing that because it
is the syntax here we don't pass any
parameter to our cylinder object as we
created so this must be calling the
default constructor which doesn't take
any parameter this is the message here
let's close our debugging session and
maximize our visual studio code instance
because we're going to set up another
constructor which is going to take
parameters now and you have seen the
syntax to do that in the slides it is
nothing complicated we're going to say
the name of the constructor which is
going to be the name of the class and
we're going to say double
and say rad param for radius and we're
going to say
height param for our
height and we're going to make this
double and after that we're going to
head in the body of our constructor and
we're going to initialize our guides to
the parameters that will pass to the
function here and this is really
powerful after we have this constructor
end we will be able to pass
parameters that will be used to
construct our cylinder object so we can
say base radius and pass in
red param and we can say height and say
height param here and these are going to
be used to construct our object now we
can head over in the main function and
change how we construct our cylinder
object if we want to use tan as the
radius and
five or four as the
height we can do that by passing
arguments to our constructor here
let's run this through the debugger
again and see that our information here
is being used
now this constructor here is going to be
chosen by the compiler because it is
more fitting for the call that we are
doing here let's run our debugging
session the program is going to be bolt
and we are going to try and maximize
this a little bit and bring up our
terminal output okay we have hit the
breakpoint here we can step into our
constructor and notice the constructor
that the compiler chooses our
constructor that takes parameters is
chosen here and we can do things inside
let's hit next we're going to initialize
the base radius to 10 and we're going to
initialize the height to
four okay we can see that to the left
here if we hit next the height is going
to be changed to four and our
constructor is going to be done we're
going to head over
in the main function again and if we
step over now we're going to print a new
volume which is based on the information
we used to construct our object here
this is really what constructors do they
are used by the compiler to build your
objects and we saw the syntax we can use
to set up constructors for our own
classes okay now you must be saying if
we need constructors to build our
objects
why was the code in the last lecture
working
in the last lecture we did something
like this we said cylinder cylinder one
cylinder one and this was welding and
compiling fine and let's try and take
out our constructors we can do that
let's comment them out and if you look
you're going to see that the code is
going to compile fine even if we don't
have any constructors in here let's
build with gcc to show you that the code
is going to compile both is good so how
is this working how is this
constructing our objects even if we
don't have any constructors in here well
the reason is the compiler is going to
set up its own constructor and what it
is going to set up is a constructor
which is really empty and doesn't have
anything inside it's basically going to
be as if we put in an empty constructor
let's copy this and actually show you
this we can do that and we're going to
make this constructor empty and not do
anything in the body this is the
constructor that your compiler is going
to generate and if we're both now and i
try to
set up a break point here you're going
to see that our empty constructor is
going to be chosen let's debug and show
you that okay you see that we're going
to hit the breakpoint here and if we
step into the compiler is going to
choose this guy and it's not going to do
anything so it's basically going to take
our member variables as
they are and it's going to use the
information to print the volume here we
can
hit next again
and get out of our constructor
and if we
step over we should print our volume
which is going to be 3.14 because the
compiler
just used the
initial values we have in our member
variables here so again the message is
if you don't have any constructor in
your class the compiler is going to
generate an empty constructor for you
and the empty constructor is going to
take no parameters and it's not going to
have anything in the body it's going to
be an empty constructor and it is called
a default constructor generated by the
compiler this is really all i had to
share in this lecture i hope you found
it interesting now you should have
enough knowledge to build your own
constructors for your classes we are
going to stop here in this lecture the
next one we're going to learn about
default constructors
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to learn about default
constructors and this is a syntax you
can use to let the compiler
generate a default constructor for you
all you have to do is do things like
this you're going to say the name of the
constructor which is going to be the
same name as the class you're going to
put in an empty parameter list and then
you're going to say equals default
if you do this the compiler is going to
generate a default empty constructor for
you
in the last lecture we have seen that we
can set up our own constructors
basically like this what i haven't told
you is that the moment you set up your
own constructor the compiler is going to
not generate the default constructor and
if you want to keep the ability to
construct objects without passing
parameters you're going to have to put
in your own default constructor and you
can use this syntax here to do that
let's head over to visual studio code
and talk about this a little more okay
here we are in our working folder the
current project is defaulted
constructors we're going to grab our
template files and we're going to put
them in place and we are going to open
this in visual studio code by dragging
and dropping here and we're going to
open our main cpp file let's take out
what we don't need we're going to clean
the main function here and we are going
to bring in the class definition we had
in the last lecture
if you remember we had two constructors
and one constructor which didn't take
any parameter and another constructor
which was initializing our member
variables with parameters that we passed
in this parameter list here but in this
lecture let's take out this constructor
that doesn't take any parameter
and show you that when you set up your
own constructor the compiler is not
going to generate a default constructor
for you and we're going to lose the
ability to construct objects without
passing parameters the syntax we
basically see here we're going to say
cylinder and say cylinder one let's use
a lowercase c and if we do this you see
that we have a squiggly line the
compiler is not going to generate an
empty non-parameter taking constructor
because it sees that we have a
constructor here this is how c plus plus
compilers work if they see that you have
any constructor in your class they're
not going to generate a default empty
constructor and if we try to build we're
going to get an arrow that says
something like
we don't have a constructor that can
basically construct an object from the
line here it's going to say no matching
function call for cylinder cylinder you
see here it is trying to call a
constructor that doesn't take any
parameter but we have no such
constructor in our code we could go in
and put in that constructor
and for example say cylinder and put an
empty parameter list and put an empty
body now this line here is going to work
because we have a default empty
constructor and if we weld you see that
the build is going to be good okay we
are building fine but having to type all
this if what you really want is an empty
constructor
is too much type in and in c plus plus
we have a syntax we can use to let the
compiler generate this kind of
constructor for us and the way we do
that is say cylinder and we say the name
of the constructor we say equals and we
say default if we save this the compiler
is going to generate this constructor
for us and the line here is going to
work so let's bring this up and build
again we're going to build with gcc
you're going to see that the build is
good and we can bring up the terminal
and clear and run rooster we're not
going to see anything because we're not
printing the volume of our cylinder here
but we can do that let's call this
cylinder one to be consistent with what
we did in the last few lectures and
we're going to say hddc out and print
the volume of this cylinder we're going
to say volume and call our volume method
and now that we have this we can weld
we're going to use gcc to do that the
build is good we can go down and clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
we see our volume here and this is
really all i wanted to share with you in
this lecture that you can use this
default syntax here to set up an empty
default constructor for your classes and
one thing i haven't shown you
is that your constructors have to be
public to be able to be called like this
and to show you that let's go up and
actually change this to private and show
you what happens the moment we do this
we're going to get a squiggly line in
the main function here and if we try to
build but before we build let's show you
what visual studio code is saying it's
going to say cylinder cylinder declared
is inaccessible so you see the
constructor which is declared inside of
a class as private
it accessible from the outside when we
try to call it to build our cylinder
objects so for constructors to be usable
on the outside here and both your
objects they have to be public let's
build and see what gcc says about this
we basically going to have the same
error the constructor is private within
this context so we can't really call it
so if we want our code to build we need
to make our constructors public and this
is something
you need to know let's build again and
see that the cold is now building the
world is good and this is really all i
had to share in this lecture we are
going to stop here in this one in the
next one we're going to see how we can
use setters and getters to modify things
about our class objects
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about setters and gators and these are
methods in our class that we can use to
read member variables or modify data in
our member variables let's look at a
simple example and by the way i am sorry
for my bad pronunciation of cylinder
here i have said it was cylinder and
after some careful thought i checked
online for the pronunciation on this and
i found that it was cylinder sorry for
this if it was bothering you i apologize
for the bad pronunciation and i am going
to do this right starting from now okay
here we have our cylinder class we have
a few member variables and we have the
base radius we have the height and now
we want to go through some public
functions to do operations on these
member variables because now that they
are private we can't really modify them
or manipulate them from the outside and
we really need to do things with them so
if we want to read things from them we
will use the getter functions
and if you look here this is a simple
function the only special thing about it
is that it leaves inside the class it
has a return value it has a function
name it has a parameter list and then
the body we're just going to return the
member variable of interest because this
is a getter we use that to get stuff
from the class this is the meaning here
here we have another getter function
which is going to return the height and
notice that these functions live in the
public scope of our class this is key
because we want to be able to go through
them to modify and do things with our
member variables but they will be used
from the outside so they must be public
otherwise they want to be accessible
from the outside we also have a pair of
setup functions they are going to be
modifying our member variables so set
base radius is going to take a parameter
that it's going to use to set a base
radius set height is going to do the
same it's going to take a parameter and
it's going to use that to assign a value
to our height member variable here and
because these functions are members of
the class
they have access to our member variables
regardless of whether they are public or
private so this is going to work we're
going to go through them from the
outside and they are going to do the
dairy work for us and do things using
our member variables to which we don't
have access to
from the outside this is the meaning
here now that you have an idea about
this we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more okay here we are in our working
folder the current project is setters
and getters we're going to grab our
template files pretty quick and put them
in place
setters and getters it is let's grab the
folder and we're going to open this in
video studio code by dragging and
dropping here this is going to open our
folder we're going to open our main cpp
file and we're going to clean it up a
little bit we are going to grab the
cylinder class from our previous lecture
and use that as a starting point here
and if you look we have a pair of
constructors here we have the volume
function which is going to give us the
volume of our cylinder here and we have
our member variables now what we want to
do is to be able to do things with these
member variables from the outside in the
main function here and we're going to go
through setter and getter methods which
must be public so let's do that so we're
going to set up our getter first so
we're going to say double get base
radius it's going to return double it's
not going to take anything and and in
the body we're just going to return our
radius let's return that okay so we're
going to set up another getter which is
going to give us the height and it's not
going to take anything and it's going to
just return our height member variable
now these are our getters they are going
to be getting things from the class
object we're going to set up other
functions that are going to be our
setters they're not going to return
anything and we're going to say set base
radius and it's going to take a double
parameter in and we're going to use that
to set our base radius so we're going to
say base radius and we're going to say
equals red parameter here and we're
going to do the same for our height so
it's not going to return anything the
function here and we're going to say set
height and we're going to take our
parameter n so i'm going to say double
height param and we're going to use that
to
assign
stuff to our member variable we're going
to say hi and we're going to say height
param okay so this is our thing here now
we have two functions to get stuff from
our class and we have two functions to
set data to our member variables here
and again remember that we can't have
direct access to these member variables
on the outside of the class and if we
want to do that we're going to be able
to do that through our setter and getter
functions now for these functions
setters and getters to be accessible
from the outside they needed to leave in
the public section of our class you see
this public keyword here is going to
apply to anything after it until we
change this to private software so the
public scope is basically going from the
constructors here
all the way to our set height function
and once we put this private keyword
here everything after that is going to
be private this is how these things work
so let's try and use this in main we're
going to set up a cylinder object
cylinder one and let's put in for
example two and three why not and now if
we want to have access to the base
radius remember if we tried to access
that directly let's say that if we try
to do something like cylinder one and
say base radius you're going to see that
we're going to have a squiggly line
meaning that there's something wrong
with our call here let's bring up a
terminal
and see what visual studio code thinks
about this membership base radius
declared this inaccessible here if we
try to weld we probably going to get a
compiler error that says that base
radius is private in this scope and
that's what we have here declare the
private here so we can't access this
from the main function here but now that
we have our getter functions we can go
through them and have access to
private member variables and notice that
because we are returning by value here
what return is going to be a copy you
really need to keep an eye for whether
what you are manipulating is the
original stuff or a copy so here we're
going to be returning by value and we're
going to return a copy but this is still
useful in some cases so here we can use
allocator let's take out this here and
say get base radius it is a method or a
function so we need to put our function
call here and now if we try to build
let's pass this through gcc and see what
we get you see the build is good we can
run this program let's clear and run
rooster you're going to see that the
base radius is two now now that we have
this sense we can actually modify stuff
about our cylinder here let's put in 10
and 10 just to be able to follow this
easily and we're going to print the
volume let's say volume and we're going
to say volume here we're not going to
use the getter here i'm going to say
volume this is going to print our volume
but we're going to modify our member
variables remember this is an object of
our cylinder class
so we're going to say cylinder 1 set
base radius we can do that and we can
change this to 100 for example and we
can change the height that height we can
use this member function because we have
it now and we're going to set this to 10
why not now if we print the volume
you're going to see that the volume has
changed because we are going through our
public
setter and getters methods so the
cylinder is now going to be using this
data and for the first case here the
cylinder is going to be using the data
we used in our constructor here let's
both and run this application the build
is good we can clear and run rooster now
for the first time we're going to see
that our volume is this number and for
the second time our volume is going to
be multiplied by 10 because we changed
the base radius to 100 and if you put
these numbers in you're going to see
that they make sense we are able to
modify our member variables through our
setter and getter functions and again
for this setter and getter functions to
work they have to be in the public scope
of your class because if you make them
private they're not going to be
accessible from the outside and you're
going to get a compiler error let's try
and do that we are learning so we're not
afraid to break things a little bit so
let's make them private we can do that
and bring this a little bit to the left
and at the moment we do that we should
have a few squiggly lines in our main
function and we do expect this because
they are private now so we have no
business accessing them from the main
function like this they are meant to be
used from the inside of the class if
they are private like this and if you
try to use them from the outside you're
going to get a compiler error let's pass
this through gcc to really see the
compiler error and we're going to get
set height is private from the context
of the main function and if we go up i
think we're going to see the same thing
for a set base radius and that's here
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture showing you how you can use
setters and getters to manipulate your
member variables from the outside
and i hope you found this useful we are
going to stop here in this lecture in
the next one we're going to show you how
you can split your class across multiple
files but before i let you go let's fix
this so that we don't have a compiler
error here so we're going to remove this
private keyword we have put here and
we're going to build again to make sure
the world is good let's use gcc for that
the world is good and i will see you in
the next lecture go ahead and finish up
here and meet me there in this lecture i
am going to show you how we can split
our class information across multiple
files so far what we have been doing is
really cramping everything in the main
function we had our constant declaration
we had our cylinder class definition and
we had our main function to use these
things all cramped into the main cpp
file now we're going to see how we can
do things better the first thing we can
do is move our constant in another file
because if you think about it users of
your class in the main function don't
care about this constant pi because it
really is an implementation detail
that should leave somewhere else or even
inside the cylinder class but we're
going to put this in a separate file
because that's going to give us room to
put as a constant if we need to do that
so if we split things up like this
when we want to use the pi variable we
will need to include the constants file
because that's going to give us access
to it but we don't have to maintain it
in the main function so this is a little
better but another thing we can do is
remove the cylinder in another separate
file and do something like this so now
you see that our cylinder declaration
and definition has moved in a file
called cylinder.h
and we have our constant pi
living in another file called
constants.h
and if we want to use our cylinder class
like we have been using it all along we
will need to include the header that
brings it in and this is how we're going
to do it and we will be able to use it
in the main function if we set things up
like this but we can go even further we
can split our class declaration and
definition in two separate files what
we're going to have in the header is
going to be really a preview of the
class
and in the cpp file which is going to be
called
cylinder.cpp we're going to have the
implementation details of our class and
again this is going to make things a
little easier to manage because it's
really not good to have everything
cramped into your main cpp file it
should really have high level details
about how your application works and all
the low level details should be split
into different files this is good design
now that you have an idea about this
let's head over to visual studio code
and show you how you can do this okay
here we are in our working folder the
current project is class across multiple
files we're going to grab our template
files and put them in place and we're
going to open this in visual studio code
so that we can really play with us this
is going to open our folder we can open
the main cpp file we are going to clean
it up a little bit and we are going to
grab our class definition and put that
on top here so this is our cylinder
class we have the constructors we have
the functions the volume function here
and we have our setters and getters
inside down we have our member variables
which happen to be private to this class
here now what we want to do is to
organize
our code better and the first thing we
need to do is to move this constant from
the main file here because it's really
not that useful at this point here users
of your classes won't really care about
what pi is because it is an
implementation detail to the cylinder
class because we are using that to
compute our volume so this constant
really has no business being in the main
file we're going to move this in a
separate file we're going to set up a
new file we're going to come to the left
here click on the plus icon here that
says new file we're going to say
constants and we're going to call this
constants.h because it's going to be a
header file and we can just come from
the
main cpp file we're going to copy this
we're going to cut this actually and
we're going to put this in our separate
file which is constants.h
after we do this we're going to come in
our main cpp file and we're going to
include that header file so let's do
that we're going to include constants.h
and the moment we do that you're going
to see now visual studio code knows
where this constant is but we don't have
to deal with that directly here another
benefit of doing things like this is
that we can go in this header file and
declare thousands of other constants and
we can have access to them in the main
function by just using this single line
that includes our file here so this is
good design if we build our application
you're going to see that it is going to
work let's try and set up a cylinder
object we're going to say cylinder 1 and
we're going to put 10 and 10 n as our
parameters and we're going to print the
volume of this little guy so this is
easy to do now we're going to say volume
and we're going to print that out
cylinder one and we're going to call the
volume method and this is going to print
our thumb and again i am going to be
using the terms functions and methods
interchangeably in this course and what
i mean in the context of the class
that's going to be the member functions
of the class so don't be confused by
this right here if we build and run this
application it should be working right
because we have everything we need for
it to work
let's see if the world was good the
build was good we can bring up a
terminal and actually run this let's
clear and run rooster this is going to
print our volume so the code is working
right the second thing we want to do is
to move this class all together in
another file because we don't really
want to see it
here in the main function what we really
want is to use stuff and we don't care
about how those things are set up in the
same logic we used when we used std
strength we didn't really care about how
hdd strength is put together all we
really wanted was to include the class
that brings it in and use it in our code
we're going to be setting up the same
behavior for our cylinder class here and
it is going to be given in its own
separate file so let's set up another
header file we're going to call this
cylinder dot h and we're going to grab
our class definition all together so
we're going to go from the bottom here
and select everything that includes our
class we're going to cut this out we're
going to go in our cylinder header and
we're going to paste this in there and
we're going to come back to our main
file and include our cylinder class so
let's do that we're going to include and
we're going to say cylinder.h
and this is going to make things work
remember the preprocessor is going to
put these things on the preprocessor is
basically going to go in constants it's
going to take whatever is inside and
then it's going to paste that here and
it's going to take everything inside our
cylinder class and it's going to paste
that here so it's basically going to be
like we are declaring these things in
the main function but our code is going
to be better organized now if we try to
build this program it is going to world
exactly like it did because we have all
the information for its world let's
build world has finished successfully so
the world is good and we can run this
program and it's going to do what it was
doing all along we can clear and run
rooster don't worry about visual studio
code here i don't know what the problem
is with that it's just having ah it's
having a problem with the pi
constant here because it's not included
in here so what we can do is say include
and include our constants header and if
we do this the problem here is going to
go away but we're going to have a
problem if we're trying to run this
program now because try to think about
it in the main function we are including
the constants header
and in the
header of cylinder we are also including
this little guy here so if the processor
comes it's going to include
this and it's going to have this little
guy inside our main function and the
cylinder is also going to include this
because it's including this header so
when the preprocessor is done we're
going to have our constant here declared
twice and if we try to build this
program you can expect bad things to
happen because it's really not good to
have the same thing defined more than
once in your entire program and let's
try and build and show you this
hopefully we're going to get a compiler
error
and it's going to blow up in our face
it's going to say hero redefinition of
const double pi so what is going on here
we are including this thing twice once
here and at the second time it's coming
in directly from the cylinder class
because we are including that in this
location here and what the preprocessor
is basically going to do it's going to
copy the entire file here and it's going
to paste that in the place of cylinder.h
here and this constants header is
basically going to be included twice so
it's going to be redefined here that's
the problem we have one way we have to
solve this in c plus plus is by using
include chords and the way we do that we
come in our constants header and we say
pound if
and def
this is a way to say
if something is not defined yet and
let's say cylinder underscore h and
we're going to say define
cylinder underscore h and we're going to
come down to the end and say and f this
is a way we have to tell the
preprocessor to only do something or
include the code we have within these
things if the condition on top here is
satisfied so for example the code inside
here is going to be put in our c plus
source file
if the cylinder name here is not defined
in the eyes of the preprocessor so it's
going to say if cylinder underscore h is
not defined i am going to define that
and i am going to put this code here but
if it's already defined it's going to
skip all these things and it's not going
to include this okay so this is the
logic here and i noticed this is really
not a cylinder file so we're going to
change this to constants
underscore h let's say that and let's do
the same here and this is going to do
our thing and we're going to go in our
cylinder header and do the same thing
and put in our include guard it is
basically a guard that is going to guard
against something
being included more than once
so let's do that in our cylinder header
so we're going to wrap this inside our
include guards we're going to say if n
def you see visual studio code is really
helping out here and we're going to put
in the name we're going to use for this
this is a cylinder class so i think it
makes sense to call this cylinder
underscore h and we're going to do the
same thing here define cylinder and
we're going to end f at the end of the
file here so we're going to say end f
and again this is the syntax of the
preprocessor i don't want to get too
much into this because we will learn
about this later in the course but we
can now use this to guard against
something being included more than once
and if we're trying to build the program
now hopefully it's going to world let's
use the gcc and now you see that the
world is good even if we are including
the constant header multiple times in
the main file here we can even go down
and do that like a thousand times so
let's do that and you're going to see
that if we try to compile it is going to
boil define because now we have a guard
guarding against including this thing
more than once the preprocessor is
basically going to come in here and say
if
the constant's name is not defined i'm
going to define that name
and i am going to put the code here in
the source file that includes me
if it happens to be already defined this
condition here is going to fail it's not
going to do any more than in this file
the preprocessor is basically going to
give up on this file here this is what i
want you to know so now we should be
able to split our code into multiple
files and now that i think about it we
don't really need to include the
constants header here because it's going
to be broadened by the cylinder class
but it was a good opportunity to teach
you about the include guards here now
that you notice we're going to remove
this and we're going to build and show
you that this is going to work anyway so
weld is good we can run our program
clear and run rooster this is going to
work the last thing i want to show you
is that we can go even further and split
our class into two separate files
because people who come to the header
file are usually interested in your
class definition they are really not
interested in your implementation
details for example they want to see
that you have a volume function and they
want to know that they can call that
function but they don't really want to
know how you compute your volume and we
can really make events simple for them
and hide the implementation details in a
separate cpp file so let's do that we're
going to set up a new cpp file we're
going to call this cylinder that's cpp
and we're going to
move the implementations
of our functions
in the cpp file and i am doing this just
to show you that it is possible in
practice you're going to have to decide
for yourself what you want to keep in
the header file and what you want to
keep in the cpp file so the cylinder
default constructor here is going to
stay this way but we can move the other
constructor here in the cpp file and the
way we do that we're going to just grab
this and i am going to change this line
by line so that you can see this
and in the cpp file the first thing we
want to do is to include the cylinder
header because the implementations here
are going to be using this
and we're going to put in our
constructor and modify it to be fit for
living in a cpp file so let's come here
and do that the way we tell this that
this is really an implementation of a
function we have in our header here is
to put the class name in front we're
going to say cylinder and put two
columns the moment we do that the
compiler is going to know that this is
an implementation of a function we have
in our header file and this is the
function here and now we can take out
the body here and live this as a
prototype for the function which is our
constructor view we can do this
okay if we do this in world the code is
going to world it's going to construct
our objects let's go back in main cpb
and make sure that that's the
constructor we are using it is we can
weld and make sure that what we just did
didn't break anything we are building
and we can clear things up a little bit
and run rooster this is going to give us
our volume and we have started to split
things up
in our class here some things are going
to leave in the header file some other
things are going to leave in the
implementation file so we have moved our
constructor here let's move the volume
function we can grab it and i move
things line by line i think this is the
best way to learn
and i think we can move this things a
little bit to the left let's do that and
we're going to say that this is a
function implementation for some
function that is declared in the class
here so we're going to say cylinder and
we're going to put two columns this is
going to tell the compiler this is an
implementation of the function we have
in our class and the return type has to
live in front of this scope resolution
operator okay what we have here cylinder
column column is called the scope
resolution operator and is basically
telling the compiler that our function
called volume leaves in the scope of the
cylinder class this is what the syntax
here is saying and this little thing
here is called a scope resolution
operator
okay so we have moved our volume
function we can now take the body out
from the class and keep the prototype
here we can go down and really practice
on the setters and gators so let's do
that so we're going to grab them all
together because now you have the gist
about how this works we can copy them
and move them into the cpp file and
we're going to fix the code lined by
line here so let's make sure they are
aligned properly we have two left to do
let's do that and i really have to show
you this life because some people are
going to have problems regarding how i
did this so i want you to see this live
as i do this i'm not going to edit this
out so we're going to put our scope
resolution operator after our return
type here i'm going to say cylinder
cylinder can't type can i okay we have
this in and we can really copy this and
paste this into place wherever it is
needed so i'm going to paste that here i
am going to paste that here and i am
going to paste that here now we have
successfully moved all the functions in
the implementation file
cylinder.cpp and we can go back in our
header and remove the bodies because we
don't need them here if we keep them
here we're going to have two definitions
for this functions and we're going to
have compiler errors let's take this out
we're going to take the body out we're
going to take the body out and we're
going to take the body out let's do that
for a gate base radius here
and now if we build our program it
should work we're going to work with gcc
see the world is good and if we try to
run the program it should give us what
it was given before this is the volume
here
one thing i want you to see is that you
don't want to keep two definitions for
your functions so for example we can
grab the body here and bring this back
in the header file i want you to see
what's going to happen if you do that i
am going to paste that in here and i am
going to move things a little bit to the
right to align things properly here so
if we do this the compiler is going to
see that we are calling that constructor
and the compiler is going to have no
problem with us but once we hit the
linker stage the linker is going to find
that we have two definitions for the
constructor here we have one in the
header and we have one in the
implementation file and this is going to
raise a compiler error saying we have
two definitions for the constructor here
and the linker want to know which one to
use so it's going to give you an error
let's build and really show you this
because this can be hard to debug if you
don't know what is happening okay you
see we have world finished with errors
and the problem is cylinder cylinder
double double is redefined we don't want
to have two definitions for the sum
function so once you move things from
header to implementation file be sure
you don't have any more definitions left
in the header or you're going to have
really hard to debug problems
and now i think we have our program
organized fairly well for what we know
so far about c plus plus we have our
constants living in another header file
and we have learnt about include cards
what we can use to guard against our
stuff being included more than once by
the preprocessor we have our cylinder
class living in its own file and again
we have an include guard here and you
can see that this class now is really
easy to look at we can look at the
information about the member functions
we have for example we have a default
constructor we have a constructor that
takes two parameters but we don't see
the details about how these things do
their jobs for example we don't see the
details about how the volume is computed
those details are hidden in the cpp file
and if you want to see them you need to
go to this implementation file here this
is a good design and i encourage to
split your c plus plus programs in
multiple files like this this is going
to make your life easier in this lecture
we're going to see how we can manage our
class objects through pointers and in
most cases we need to manage our class
object through pointers if we are using
some form of dynamic memory allocation
here is a simple example we have our
cylinder class included and down here
you see that we can create cylinder
objects on the stack if we use the
syntax like we do here the objects are
going to be created on the stack and we
have seen that we can access the
behaviors or data inside our class
object using the data notation like we
do here for example here we are calling
our volume function but sometimes we
want to manage our objects through
pointers for example if you look at the
syntax we have here we are saying
cylinder and using the asterisk here
this is going to say that this is going
to be a pointer to a cylinder type
and i'm going to give it a name c2 and
we can allocate our object on the heap
using the new operator this is going to
dynamically allocate space from the heap
and that memory space is going to be
used to store our cylinder object now
the interesting thing is going to happen
when you try to access behaviors from
your cylinder object here for example if
we look at this line here we are trying
to print the volume of this cylinder and
you notice that we have to go through
ugly dereferencing here we have to
dereference the object and then call our
method through the dot operator here but
what i want you to see is that we can
avoid this ugly the reference that we
are doing here and use the pointer
access notation this dash greater than
symbol you see here is going to allow us
to access stuff directly using the
pointer to an object that is dynamically
allocated on the hip okay after we are
done using our cylinder object remember
it is memory that was dynamically
allocated from the hip we have to
release the memory so that it can be
used by the operating system and we
release the memory using the delete
operator as we do here okay the idea i
wanted to introduce here is that we can
use players to manage our cylinder
objects and this is one way we can do
this and once we are using a pointer as
a handle to our cylinder object we can
use the pointer access operator here to
access stuff from our class objects
easily and another thing you should know
is that we can actually create a
cylinder object and store in the address
of objects that we have on the stack and
we're going to see this in a minute when
we hit visual studio code now that you
have an idea about this let's head over
to visual studio code and play with this
a little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
managing class objects through pointers
we can see the entire name here and now
we're not going to grab our template
project because we want to start from
the project we had in this lecture on a
class across multiple files so we're
going to go in that project and grab
everything from there
except for the executable because we
obviously don't want this
and we're going to go in our current
project and paste in the code and this
is going to give us a good starting
point so we can grab this and open
this project in visual studio code it's
going to open the folder and we're going
to have everything we want to start
doing what we want to do in this lecture
here so now we should have access to our
cylinder class and if you look here we
have an object of cylinder type already
created by this line on liner number six
here and we have seen that we can use
the syntax like cylinder volume here
using the dot call operator to access
stuff from our class object and this is
going to work but we want to see that we
can use pointers to manage our object
here and the first thing i want you to
see is that we can manage a stack object
through pointers and to really show this
off let's set up a
another variable it's going to be a
cylinder pointer and it's going to be p
cylinder one it's going to be a pointer
to cylinder one here that's what i mean
and we can give it an address of
cylinder one as a value so we can do
that for example and put in the address
of operator and this is going to work
now we can go through our pointer here
and do stuff with this cylinder object
but the syntax is going to be pretty
ugly so for example let's try and print
the volume of our cylinder
we're going to say htdcl and say volume
can save that and we're going to have to
go through the dereference operator so
if we do something like p cylinder one
and try to use the dot operator
you're going to see that we have the
volume function but if we try to call it
let's do that let's make sure we are
using the dot operator here if we try to
compile this program it's not going to
compile because
we are trying to call stuff from a
pointer and remember a pointer is just
going to store an address it doesn't
really have information about the type
that it is pointing to if we try to
compile this program we're going to get
a compiler error so let's use gcc to do
that
and we're going to get request for
member volume in pc lender 1. remember p
cylinder 1 is just a pointer it's not an
object so we can't really call the
volume function to f
if we want to use the dot call operator
here we have to the reference and
actually get to the actual
object that the pointer is pointing to
and we do that using the star operator
you already know how to dereference a
pointer so we can dereference our
pointer and then call the volume
function on what the pointer is pointing
to and this is going to work it's going
to print out volume let's build now now
that we are dereferencing correctly and
you see that this is going to work and
if we try to print this let's bring up a
terminal so that we can run this program
let's run rooster you're going to see
that we have our volume here so to
really get to what is pointed to
you need to use the reference operator
and then call whatever method you want
to call on your object but we can do
things even easier there is a syntax we
can use to use the pointer directly here
because going through all this
dereferencing ugliness is really not
cool so we're going to grab this and
show you that we can use the dash
greater than operator that's how i
called it
and if we use that we don't need to the
reference
all we need to do is use the dash
greater than symbol here and it's going
to
directly tell the compiler don't code
stuff on the pointer directly do the
reference the pointer internally and
then call the volume function on
whatever you get after referencing so
this is basically going to push the the
referencing ugliness here behind the
curtains of the compiler and we can use
a nice syntax like this and i think this
is much better than what we were doing
here so if we try to bolt now we're
going to build and print our volume
you're going to see the bolt is good you
can clear and run rooster you see we see
our volume here so this is what i want
you to see it is possible to manage your
cylinder objects through pointers and
this is one way we can do this by
managing a stack object through pointers
and this is what we are doing here if
you want to call stuff on your class
object you can either do the ugly stuff
we do here or you can use the nice
pointer access operator and it is going
to be cool okay now that we have seen
this let's see another use case in which
we're going to be creating a cylinder
object on the heap through the new
operator okay we can go down and save
that we're going to say cylinder pointer
it's going to be p
c lender 2. we can call it like this and
then we're going to say new cylinder and
you're going to see that we can call a
constructor
we have two types of constructors we can
call we're going to call our constructor
that takes two parameters and we can
pass in 100 and
100 why not oh let's put the two after
here we can put in whatever we want this
is going to create a new cylinder object
the space for the cylinder object is
going to be allocated on the hip so this
is a hip object and because we are using
the new operator here
the other thing you should have in mind
is that you will need to release this
memory and let's go and do that directly
this is a good practice because you will
forget to release your memory if you
don't really keep this in mind so we are
going to delete p cylinder 2 because
that's what we used to allocate our hip
memory here okay now that we have taken
care of memory management we can go in
and use our p cylinder to object
and for example we can print its volume
by using the stdc out statement here so
let's go down and save that
let's align this properly and we're
going to say volume
cylinder 2 to really make this super
clear and then we're going to say p
cylinder 2
and call the volume function here this
is going to work let's draw in world the
world is good we can clear and run
rooster this is going to give us our
volume and if we try and use this
information to create a cylinder we're
going to see that the volume is what we
see here we can even try and print its
base radius
let's do that we're going to say sdd cl
we're going to say p cylinder 2 and
we're going to say base radius we can
hit the dot operator here you're going
to see we're going to have a few options
in a visual studio code here if we
double click on get base radius here
you're going to see that visual studio
code is going to use the pointer access
operator here and this is really cool so
we can hit std and yeah we can close the
left pane here because we need some more
breathing space and if we try to
build and run this program and we have a
compiler error here and the reason is
get base radius is a function
if we go back in our cylinder class we
see that we have a function called get
base radius so if we want to call this
in the main function we need to call
that as a function so we need to put a
pair of parentheses here and if we build
we should build without a problem let's
do that again
you see the build is good and if we run
the program we're going to see exactly
what we expect let's run a rooster we're
going to see what we expect here and the
message here was really that you can
manage your
class object through pointers one case
is when you have a pointer that is
pointing to a stack object and we saw
that we could do that here we can also
use pointer notation to allocate
objects on the heap and point to them
with our pointer here and whenever we
are using a pointer we have the option
to use the pointer call operator here to
do things easily i am going to be
calling this the pointer call operator
to mean this from here on if we happen
to need this and you should know what i
mean by that this is really all i set
out to share in this lecture i hope you
found it interesting we are going to
stop here in this lecture the next one
we're going to learn about these
structures
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about these structures these
structures are spatial functions or
methods in a class that are called by
the compiler to destroy your object and
these are going to be especially useful
if you are for example allocating memory
in your constructors
let's look at the simple example here we
have a class called dog it has two
sections the public section and the
private section in the public section we
have two constructors a default
constructor that doesn't take any
parameter and a constructor that takes
two parameters n
the parameters are going to be used to
initialize our member variables and they
are passed by a value here for
simplicity and they are going to be used
to initialize these member variables
doug name dog breed and dog age
the special thing about this class is
that it has a destructor and you declare
the destructor using this
syntax here he puts a tilde character in
front you say the name of the class and
then you put an empty parameter list it
is also possible to declare a destructor
and put in its entire body in the header
and this is the syntax to do this
inside the body you're going to do
whatever it is you need to destroy your
object for example if the class here is
allocating some memory in the
constructor the destructor is the best
place to release that and this is an
example of how you can do that here is a
more direct example of how we allocate
for dynamic memory in the constructor
and release that memory in the
destructor we have our three variables
but we have chosen to allocate
our dog edge variable on the heap using
dynamic memory allocation and after we
dynamically allocate a piece of memory
to store our age variable we're going to
set that to 0 because we are in a
constructor if we are using the three
parameter constructor here we might use
the past parameter to initialize our age
variable but the important thing here is
that it is being
dynamically educated memory on the hip
here and when our object dies we need to
remember to release that memory and the
destructor is the best place to release
that memory as you see here we say
delete dark age when our object dies and
the compiler is going to call this
function when it's about to kill the
object
so you might ask when are destructors
really called we are going to start by
looking at obvious cases here for
example when a local stack object goes
out of scope
the destructor is going to be called
because that object is going to be wiped
out from memory so this is an obvious
case
in which the compiler will need to call
a destructor also when a hip object is
released from memory using delete the
destructor is also going to be called
but there are some indirect ways in
which the structures are also called for
example when an object is passed by a
value to a function
this is going to call the destructor to
kill the object when the object goes out
of scope in the function because when an
object is passed by value we're going to
have a copy in the local scope of the
function and when the function exits
that local copy is going to be killed
and we're going to see an example of
that another case where you might have
the the structure called is when a local
object is returned from a function
another copy is going to be created to
be used outside the function and the
copy inside the function is going to be
killed but this is not guaranteed as
some compiler may optimize your return
value and use some kind of reference so
you're not guaranteed to see this
behavior but it is possible to see it
now that you have an idea about
destructors it's time we headed over to
visual studio code and play with us a
little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
the structures we're going to grab our
template files pretty quick and we're
going to put them in place and after
that we're going to open our folder in
visual studio code by dragging and
dropping here this is going to open our
folder and we will see our main cpp file
here we can open it and i clean up and
remove what we don't need we have an
unneeded breakpoint here we can remove
that and we're going to clean up the
main function the first thing we want to
do is to put in our dog class i am going
to just put this in here because i don't
want you to watch me type all this
that's just going to waste your time we
have two sections in the dog class we
have a public section which is going to
now contain our constructors and we have
a private section which is going to
contain three member variables we have
two strengths one for the name and the
other for the breed of our dog and we
have another one which is an end pointer
which is going to store the edge of the
dog and you see that this is initialized
to no pointer one thing you should
notice is that for our parameter taken
constructor we are passing the string
information here using string views to
avoid copies with the std string view
type you already know this because we
learned about this but for this to work
we will need to include a string view so
let's do that and now we have our class
and we can use it however we want
so but before we do we need to put in
the implementations for these functions
one way we can do that is do that
directly in the function here but i want
you to see that you can also do that
directly outside the class here i don't
think i have shown you this but it is
possible to do that so we're going to
grab the prototype for our constructor
and say the scope resolution operator
and we're going to just paste in what we
have copied which is the prototype here
and we're going to go inside put in our
body and in the body we're going to
initialize these three guys
so the name is going to be initialized
to nem param and the bridge is going to
be initialized to breed the param we can
do that and the age is going to be
dynamically allocated from the hip you
see that it is a pointer so we're going
to say ph equals new and because we're
going to allocate dynamic space to store
an end and we're going to put data in
using our good old dereference operator
we're going to say ph
equals whatever ph parameter they passed
and i think we should say edge here
because it's not a pointer so we're
going to say age i think this is going
to do better age param this is probably
going to be better and we're going to
say age param okay so now we have our
constructor n and it's going to allocate
memory from the heap and we're going to
put data in that new memory location
that has just been allocated to our
class here so this is our class and we
can go in the main function and really
use it however we want for example we
can set up a dog object so we're going
to say my dog and we're going to give it
a name the name is going to be fluffy
and we're going to put the breed in and
it's going to just be a shepherd and
we're going to put in the age which is
going to be for example a 2. let's say
our dog is 2 years old
this is valid c plus plus code it's
going to be setting up an object of our
class here and we can world to see that
this program is going to world without a
problem so both is good but if we run
the program we're not going to see
anything but we don't really need to see
our constructor here called because we
already know about constructors what we
want to learn about are these structures
and these are spatial methods that are
called by the compiler when your object
dies let's set up a destructor and see
it called when our dog objects die the
syntax to do that is to use the tilde
character here you're going to say the
name of the class you're going to put an
empty parameter list and if you want you
can put a body and do whatever you want
to do in the body of your destructor
here but again we're going to move the
entire definition of the destructor to
the outside so let's go down and save
that we're going to say the scope
resolution operator we're going to say
dog and we're going to put in our body
and the first thing we want to do in our
destructor is to release this memory
that was dynamically allocated for us if
we don't release it when this dark
object dies we're going to link memory
and that's really bad so let's do that
directly in the destructor we can say
delete and say ph this is going to
release the memory that was allocated in
the constructor here and we have access
to this ph variable because the
destructor is part of our class
any member function of your class is
going to have access to any member
variable even if it happens to be
private
okay so we forgot our tilde character
let's put that in here and this is going
to be valid c plus plus code but to
really see things happening here let's
put in an sddc out statement we're going
to say doug destructor called 4 and
we're going to say the name of the dog
let's say name and we're going to say
the same thing in the constructor we're
going to say hddcl and say dog
constructor cold for and we're going to
say the dog name going to use our member
variable and now we have our thing in
place we have the destructor declared in
the class definition and this is the
syntax again this is what we really want
to learn about in this lecture we have
the tilde character we have the class
name and we put an empty parameter list
let me tell you that it is not possible
to pass parameters to your destructor if
you do that you're going to get a
compiler error the structures will
always have no parameters in c plus plus
here we have the definition of our
destructor and it is going to release
whatever memory we have dynamically
allocated from the constructor here if
we run this program
we're going to see our constructor
called as a result of this line here
because we are constructing a dog object
and we're going to see the destructor
called when the main function is about
to end
let's put an stdc out state to mention
the main function here and say done just
to prove that we have hit the end of our
main function here i think this is
useful and we're going to build so let's
do that we're going to build with gcc
you're going to see that the world is
good so we can clear and run or program
let's hit enter here and clear and run
rooster you're going to see that the
constructor was called we are going to
say done when the main function is about
to end but before the main function ends
we're going to destroy any stack data
that we have in the main function and
our dog object is on the stats so it's
going to be destroyed as part of that
process and the destructor for dog is
going to be called and we're going to
release our memory and we're going to
say that dog destructor was called for
whatever name
we have assigned to our dog here so this
is how destructors are called when your
objects are killed
and we didn't put in the correct name
we said fluffy let's say fluffy because
that's what i wanted and now you see
that our destructor is really being
called and releasing memory however we
want but we can also go a little further
and show you another example of a case
where the structures are called and
we're going to look at a function that
sets up a local object of a dog we're
going to see the dog constructed and
we're going to see it destroyed when the
function is about to end let's do that
we're going to say void some funk and
it's going to be just some function to
play with us we're going to
move our dog declaration in some funk
here
and this is really it we're going to
call this function
and when we call it we're going to
construct the object here when the
function is about to end the compiler is
going to call the destructor because
it's going to destroy this object here
and we're going to see the destructor
called by that point the some funk
function is going to be popped off the
top of the stack we're going to hit the
main function here and we're going to
say done and the program is going to end
let's call some funky name here so we're
going to say some funk and we're going
to world to really see this happening so
we have worked successfully we can clear
clear properly and run rooster we're
going to see constructor called for
fluffy the structure called for fluffy
and you see done we have hit the main
function and really finished executing
our program here we can even see this
through the debugger we're going to set
up three break points one in the main
function here before we call the some
funk function we're going to set up
another one in our destructor before we
print the message here and we're going
to put another one in the constructor
when we are about to print this message
here on line 20. after we set up these
break points we kind of kill the
terminal here and minimize a little bit
let's kill these things here so that we
have a clean ah we have a lot of windows
here okay we have our editor here
and now if we go to the tab here that
says start or run we're going to be able
to click the green button here to start
our debugging session we are going to
have a terminal here so let's bring that
to the side so that we can see things
printed out nicely let's do like this
and now we have hit the break point in
the main function we can step into
the sum func function and we're going to
do that using the step into button here
let's click that we're going to jump
into some funk
now we have the option to step into but
this is going to jump us into the logic
of transforming the string literal here
into a string view because if you see
the constructor is going to take string
view parameters we can actually see this
let's try
and hit the step into button you see
that we are in the string view class and
we don't really want this so let's step
out and we're going to step over this
so that we can hit the next breakpoint
and you see the next breakpoint is in
our constructor and this proves that the
compiler is going to call our
constructor here to build our object
if we step over this we're going to
print the message from the constructor
and if we keep going we're going to get
out of
our constructor and you see where this
is going to go this is going to go in
the destructor because before we leave
the some func function our dot objects
is going to be destroyed so we're going
to release our memory and we're going to
branch the message from our constructor
and if we hit next and a step out of
this i think we can do that because this
is logic we don't want we're going to
try and step over this and now if we hit
next we're going to come back in some
funk and some funk is already going to
be finished and if we hit next we're
going to come back in main and we're
going to print done and the program is
basically going to be done hopefully you
can see that
the compiler is going to call our
destructor after it leaves some funk
here because it's going to be destroying
the local object that we have inside
some funk here so this is one case where
the destructor is going to be called by
the compiler and it is if you have a
local object that needs to be destroyed
when function scope finishes another
case where the destructor may be called
is if you pass
a
class object
parameter by value so let's change some
function here and make it take something
by value so we're going to pass a dog
inside and we're going to say dog param
this is going to do okay now that we
have changed some func here we can
really do all kinds of crazy things with
it for example we can set up our dog
object inside our main function here so
let's do that we can say dog and dog the
variable name is going to be dog we can
give it
a name which is going to be fluffy it's
going to have a breed of shepherd and we
can give it the age of 2 like we have
been doing all along we can call our
function with the dog object here but be
careful about what is going to happen
here when we do something like this
we're going to be passing by value and
the compiler is going to see that it
needs to copy a dog object
now we haven't really told our class
here how to copy dog objects and we do
that through constructors we call copy
constructors we haven't really learned
about yet but what the compiler is going
to do by default is copy these things
member by member so it's going to set up
a doug copy object which is going to be
initialized with empty strings and a
null pointer here and then it's going to
copy from our dog object
that we have here it's going to take the
name and copy that in the name member
variable of our dark copy it's going to
take the breed and copy that n in the
second member variable here and it's
going to take the age from our dog and
copy that in the problem is going to
come to this pointer here it's going to
copy the address and it's not going to
copy what it's pointed to and this is
going to be a recipe for a disaster i
don't really want to go through this
right now but if we try to run this
program it's not going to work like we
expect for example if we pass fluffy
here we're going to see
things that we don't expect so let's try
to build we're going to build with gcc
and the bolt is good so what we expect
is to have the constructor of fluffy
here called and we're going to copy the
dot object for use in some funk here and
to set up this copy it's not this
constructor here that is going to be
called
so it's not our constructor here which
is going to be called so we're not going
to see
this called for the copy that we set up
inside some funk another thing is
because now these two dog objects are
pointing to the same thing because what
we just copied is the address as we see
in our member variable here the two dog
objects are going to be pointing to the
same thing in memory and when we hit the
destructor we're going to call delete
twice and this is going to be a recipe
for disaster our application could
really crash you already know that
deleting a pointer twice is really bad
we shouldn't do this and we are doing
this here because we are copying i
realize this is a slightly confusing
example
but what i want you to know is that if
you pass a class object by value like
this
the copy you have inside is going to
cause for the destructor to be called
when the function exits because the copy
is going to be scoped inside the
function here so let's take out this
example because it really is confusing
but i hope you know that and i am going
to show you that another case where you
might see the destructor called is when
you call the destructor explicitly using
the delete operator on your object so we
can set up some func again let's do that
some funk and we're going to repurpose
it and inside we're going to set up a
dag object so let's grab this and reuse
that in our function here and we're
going to say dog pointer so let's say
dog pointer we're going to say p dog p
underscore dog it's going to be equals
to new dog and we're going to pass in
what we need to initialize our dog
object with this is going to create a
dark object on the hip and it is going
to be pointed to by p dog here
now i want you to see that if we don't
explicitly release the memory that we
allocate through the new operator we're
going to leak memory so we created an
object on the hip here but we're not
deleting that in some funk when some
funk exits we're going to lose this
pointer this variable because it is on
the stack itself and we won't have any
way to release this memory let's call
some funk here and really show you this
so we're going to call some funk and
we're going to build let's use gcc for
that the build is good we can bring this
up a little bit and clear and run
rooster we're going to see that the
constructor for fluffy was called
because of this new operator but we
didn't see the destructor called and
this is really bad
so for the destructor to be called we
need to explicitly release the memory in
this function here and we do that by
using the delete keyword and saying the
pointer that is pointing to the memory
that we want to release if we do this
this is going to cause for the the
structure of doubt to be called and if
we run we're going to see our destructor
called let's do that we're going to use
gcc the bolt is good you can clear and
run rooster now you see that the
constructor is called full fluffy and we
have the destructor cold this is really
all i wanted to share with you in this
lecture i apologize if you found it
confusing but if you have any problem i
am always available please do ask and i
will do the best i can to help you out
so the destructor is a special method
which is going to be called when your
object dies it is going to be called
when an object is passed by a value to a
function we have seen an example that
it's going to be called when a local
object is returned from a function by
value but this is going to be compiler
dependent because some compilers are
going to optimize this out and make it
look like when you returned by reference
so i don't want to go into this because
this is subject to compiler optimization
but other cases where you're going to
have your destructor called is when a
local stack object goes out of scope and
when a hip object is deleted
through the delete key world this is
really all i had to share in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this one
and the next one we're going to see the
order in which constructors and these
structures are called and you really
need to be aware of this
go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
and this lecture i wanted to raise your
awareness on the order in which
constructors and the structures are
called suppose we have our class which
is dug here and we have the constructor
which is doing its thing in the body
here and we have the destructor which is
releasing our memory and printing
something out so suppose we have created
a few objects
of this class here and they have
different names and they have the same
breed and different edges as you see
here
and if we run this code in main
what do you think will see printed from
the constructors and the destructors if
you asked me and i was learning about c
plus plus i would say that the
constructors are going to be called in
order dog one dog two dog three dog four
they are going to be constructed in this
order and the destructors would be
called in the same order but this is not
true the destructors are going to be
called in the reverse order as you see
on the right here
so we're going to call this constructor
for doug d1 delegate2w3 doge4 which is
exactly what i expected but you're going
to see that the destructors are going to
be called in reverse order so the object
that was constructed last
is going to be destroyed first as you
see here and the object that was
constructed first is going to be
destroyed
last and the compiler follows this order
to make it easy for it to do things we
can't really get into those details but
for now we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with us a
little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
order of constructor and destructor
calls here we're going to grab our
template project pretty quick
and we're going to put them in place the
files i mean and we're going to open
this in visual studio code like we have
been doing all along this is going to
open up our folder we can close the left
sidebar here and let's clean up our main
function we are going to bring in the
class for dog from the last lecture this
is exactly what we had there
no change and we're going to include the
string review library for this to work
so we're going to include string view
here and once we do this we're going to
head over in the main function and set
up a few
objects of the dog class here but before
we go there notice that we have a few
htdc out statements in our constructor
and destructor and we want to see the
order in which they are called so we're
going to set up four objects of our dog
we're going to say dog dog one and we're
going to say the name to be won and it's
going to be a shepherd and it's going to
be for example 2 years old why not we
should say dog here and we are going to
copy these four times here and we're
going to call this dog 2
the other is going to be dog 3 and this
is going to be dog 4
and i'm going to say the same thing here
doggy two
three and four
the names are what is really important
because we're going to see them printed
out here but if you want you can change
the ages let's make this a three let's
make this a five let's make this a one
why not for dougie for and now we're
going to run our program if we run it
we're going to see the constructors
called in the order doggy one doggie 2
w3 dog e4 and the destructors are going
to be called in the reverse order
dogifur
all the way to doggy one let's boil and
show you that this is actually the case
so the build is good we can bring up a
terminal and really run this let's clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
dog constructor called for a doki one
all the way to dog e4 and now we have
the dagger destructor called from doge4
all the way to doge one and the compiler
is going to enforce this order for
calling constructors and destructors
because it makes it easy for it to
manage the memory of objects for example
if duck one has been around for a long
time and it has because it's going to be
around before a dog one
if you
delete duck one
after dog four here there might be other
objects that depend on dog one so that's
why the object that was created the last
is deleted first because chances for
other objects to depend on that last
object are really slim and you can
delete it without any problem but the
object that was created first might have
other dependencies and you're going to
be deleting dependent object first
before you delete that object i think
this is the logic the compiler follows
to really enforce this order here and
you need to be aware of that and make
sure that at any time in your c-plus
plus application this is working to your
advantage this is really all i had to
share in this lecture i hope you found
it interesting we are going to stop here
in this one and the next one we're going
to learn about the this pointer go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about the this pointer and this is a
special pointer that is maintained by c
plus plus to really help you manipulate
the current object and it is the current
object for which a given method is being
executed here is a simple example with
our dog class and we're going to show
some usefulness for the this pointer the
first thing we're going to look at is
the syntax for example here we might
need to print the address in memory
where the object was created and do that
from the inside of the function and to
do that we use the this pointer for
example we can put out a message and we
can do that through a statement like we
have here we are printing dog dog name
constructed at a given memory address
and we use the this keyword to get the
address of the character object for
which a specific method or function is
being called in this case it was the
constructor of the dot object here we
can also do the same thing for the other
constructor and you see we are using the
this pointer this is one of the uses you
have for the this pointer again the this
pointer is a special pointer that is
maintained by the c plus plus system and
it is going to be pointing to the
current object that is being manipulated
by the z plus plus run time and it's
going to be manipulated through a
special function of the class object
that is being called this is the meaning
here here is another use case for the
this pointer it may be used to resolve
conflicts when you have a parameter and
a member variable that are named the
same way for example here we are calling
the set name function it has a parameter
with a name doug name and it has a
member variable called dog name so if
you do a statement like we have on top
here the compiler is going to be
confused they're going to say dog name
equals dog name and it won't really know
which dog name you are referring to we
can resolve this conflict by saying
this and say pointer access notation
and say dog name and this thing here is
going to be the member variable and
we're going to be assigning to the
member variable from the parameter this
is the meaning here and we can use the
desperator to resolve such conflicts
another use we have for use pointer is
if we want to set up chained calls for
example using pointers and we might need
to do something like this so we have a
dog pointer set up on top here and we
can do something with our new object for
example we can call a function called
printful on a dog object after we print
the information we're going to set some
information on the doc and you see we
are setting all of the information
through one statement the way we achieve
this our setters are going to be
returning a pointer to the current
object and we're going to be grabbing
that return value and calling
on it directly because it's a pointer
and we are going to be using the pointer
access notation so we're going to call
set name set name is going to return a
pointer we're going to use that pointer
to say to the breed and set the breed is
going to return a pointer we're going to
use that pointer to set the age and
after this entire line all the
information is going to change about our
dog and we can see that here and after
we do whatever we want with our dog
object we're going to release it from
memory so this is another thing you can
achieve using the this pointer and this
is how you can set up these setters it
is nothing complicated we have set name
it's going to return the dot pointer and
we're going to return this okay and this
is going to be a pointer or the memory
address of the current object of the dog
class we have the same setup for seti
dog breed we return the dog pointer and
we return this the same setup for set
doug age we return a dog pointer and we
return
this we can do the same thing using
references but our setup is going to be
somewhat a little bit different
we have our dog object here and we're
going to do our change call here so
we're going to say set name through the
pointer
because we have a dot pointer here but
after that we're going to return a
reference from the functions here so set
name is going to return a reference
we're going to go through that reference
to set the breed
set dog breed is going to return a
reference and we are going to go through
that reference to set the dog age and if
we print the information now we're going
to see that we have new information in
our dog object and after we are done
with our dog object we have to remember
to release it from memory because it was
allocated dynamically from the heap here
is how you can set this up it really is
nothing complicated we just have our
setters and we are going to return a
reference but before we return through
the desperator we will need to
dereference the displayer and get to the
actual thing that is being pointed to
that's why we have this star operator
here and for the other setters we're
going to do the same thing we're going
to return a reference we're going to
return a dereferenced version of this
we're going to return a dog reference
for set dog age and we're going to
return a dereferenced this pointer
because this is the reference we are
returning here so this is what the this
pointer is about now we're going to head
over to visual studio code and play with
us a little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
the displayer we're going to grab our
template files and we're going to put
them in place and then we're going to
open this in visual studio code by
dragging and dropping here this is going
to open our folder we're going to open
the main cpp file and we're going to
close the left sidebar here
so that we have some more space to work
with i am going to put in a version of
our dog class
it is pretty limited right now it just
has a destructor and a constructor and a
constructor and we have our member
variables and we're going to
tune this a little bit so that we can
work with us however we want the first
thing we want to do is to print the
addresses of dug objects that we
construct and destruct here and we're
going to do that in our constructor so
let's go to our hd dc out statement here
and we're going to say add to mean the
memory address where the object was
constructed and we're going to say this
so when we do this this is going to be
the address in memory of the current
object that is being constructed
by our constructor here and we're going
to say the same thing in our destructor
we're going to say at and we're going to
say the memory address where the current
object is being destroyed from so after
we do this
if we go in the main function and for
example set up a doug object we're going
to say dark we're going to say dog one
and we're going to give it the
information we're going to give it the
name which is going to be fluffy we're
going to give it the breed which is
going to be a shepherd and we're going
to give it the age of two like we have
been doing all along when we do
something like this this is going to
call the constructor because we are
trying to set up an object and before
the main function ends we're going to
call the destructor and we're going to
see things happening here let's say done
so that we know that the code is
actually running i'm going to say sddc
out done here okay we have the setup
done
we can uh build and run the application
we're going to use gcc to build and the
build is good we can bring up a terminal
to try and run the application and now
if we run rooster we're going to see
that dog constructor called for a fluffy
at this memory location and the current
object is this object here which is
being constructed and we're going to
have access to its memory through the
this pointer hopefully you can see how
powerful this is if we didn't have the
this pointer the only way to get the
address to
this object would be to grab the address
from the main function or from wherever
we are setting up our object here but we
have access to this address from the
inside of the functions for the class
and this is really cool so we can
manipulate these addresses if we need to
and we're going to show you another use
for this so suppose we need to set up
setters for our class here so we need a
setter to set the name the breed and to
set the age here so let's set up our
setters we're going to say setters and
we're going to say void set
name or let's be explicit set dog name
that's going to be better and we're
going to pass a string view we're going
to say stds friend of you and we're
going to say name program and we're
going to put the bodies in our class
here but i would encourage you to be
consistent if you are doing this in real
code we are learning here and we are
taking some shortcuts so that we can do
things simply but what we want to see
now is what happens if we have a
parameter named the same as a member
variable so how do you set
this name to the member variable called
the name so if you have a case like this
you're really going to be in trouble
because if you say name equals name
let's try this
we should get a compiler error or a
squiggly line because the compiler is
not going to know
which name are you using here is it the
memorial is it the parameter it's not
going to know and let's try to build and
see what we get we're going to use the
gcc
and surprisingly gcc is taking this
and it's probably knowing that we have a
member variable named name and it's
going to assign the parameter to that
member variable so behind the scenes gcc
is going to change this to this it's
going to use this name equals name
this is the syntax we want which is
really not confusing but what we have on
top here is going to be confusing and
some compilers are not even going to
take this let's leave this in and
actually build it in with us i want to
see that this actually works so we're
going to weld successfully and if we go
down in main and try to say
dog one set dog name let's say pumbaa
let's see what happens if we do
something like this we're going to try
and build again and gcc is going to take
this and this is really cool so let's
put in a function which is going to
print information about our dog we can
do that down here and it's going to
return nothing it's going to be called
print info and it's going to basically
print the name of the breed and the age
so it's going to say sddc out we're
going to say the address where the dot
object leaves
i think that's more meaningful we're
going to say this and then we're going
to
put a parenthesis and say the name i
think we can put a an angle bracket here
and say name and we're going to say the
dog name we can go down and say the age
or the breed and say the age and we're
going to dereference the age member
variable because it's a pointer we're
going to say the reference ph here and i
think this is going to be it now we can
put a new line character std e ndm and
if we go down now and say printable
before we set the name we're going to
say
dub1
printful we're going to print the
information about this dog and after we
set the dog name we're going to go down
and also say dog one principle you can
play with these things and i really
encourage you to do so so we're going to
build this we're going to use gcc so the
world is good we can clear and run
rooster this is going to say the
constructor was called for fluffy at the
given address
we're going to say the dog we're going
to print the information and we're going
to say it's a dog object at this address
the name is fluffy and we're going to
print the dog for the second time you're
going to see that the name is still
fluffy and we have a problem here why is
that
why is our object not being modified
let's go up and see our set dog name
function here so we're going to
remove this and we're going to use the
this pointer and we're going to
weld again and let's clear now and run
rooster and now you see that the changes
are actually making sense so what is
happening with the assignment here the
compiler is assigning the value of the
variable to the variable itself and this
is really doing nothing and it is not
what you expect i was fooled a little
bit by the compiler because this was
compiling but it's not going to do what
you want when you call set doug name you
probably want to take this name and
assign that to the member variable name
of this class but this is not what it's
going to do let's build again and really
show you this
so it is a really good advice to
practice and really try things out
yourself we're going to run a rooster
you're going to see that after we set
the dog name here to pumbaa and we try
to print the information the information
is not going to be end the name is not
going to be pumbaa for the second call
here and what this is really doing is
doing nothing here this does nothing and
you really need to know this if you want
to affect
your remember variable you will have to
go through the this pointer and this is
going to tell
take the name member variable of
the current object and assign the value
in name the name parameter to that and
that's going to set your name to
whatever new name you passed when you
called the set dog name function here so
hopefully you really understand this now
if we both are going to see that the
pumbaa name has been applied let's boil
again so we're going to clear and run
rooster and we're going to see now that
the name is pumbaa and there is some
annoying thing we have in our
constructors we don't have a space
before at here and it is really annoying
to look at here so let's build again and
fix this we are going to use gcc the
world is good we can clear and run
rooster and now we have what we want so
this is the second use case you might
have for this pointer through setters
let's use the parameter that is named
the same as your member variables so
we're going to set up all the other
setters we're going to set up a setter
for the breed we're going to say std
strength view and it's going to be breed
we can do that because now we have tools
to really do this properly we're going
to say this breed and we're going to say
equals read this is going to do and we
can set the age and we're going to say
void set age
dog age and we're going to pass in a
value and we're going to go inside what
is it called it's called ph i don't
think it makes sense to call the
parameter ph because it's not a pointer
so we're going to go inside and just the
reference of a pointer so we're going to
dereference that
and we're going to say this so we're
going to go inside and say this ph
equals h i think this is going to work
and we need to reference this pointer
because what we have as a member
variable is the pointer so we need to go
through the ugly syntax you see here and
this is going to set our age so we can
go through this and really change the
information so we're going to change the
breed here set dog breed let's go down
and choose that and we're going to say
wirefox terrier and we're going to go
down and set the age we're going to say
guilt 1 set dog age and we're going to
say for why not so we change the
information of our dog through our
setters here and we're going to print
new information
let's build again we're going to use gcc
for that the build is good we can clear
and run rooster this is going to give us
new information for the second print
here so name is going to be pumba breed
is going to be wirefox terrier and age
is going to be four and we have the
information for our dog object here okay
now we have this and we want to see how
we can set up chained calls
using the this pointer and in this case
we will be using pointers let's change
our setters to return dog pointers we
can do that and we're going to go down
to say to dog breed we're going to
return the dog pointer
and we're going to go to set dog age and
we're going to return a dog pointer now
after we do this we will need to return
these pointers and we're going to go
inside and say return this remember this
contains the memory of the current
object so we can return this and fit
that to a returned pointer so we can go
down in all the other functions and
really save this we're going to say
return thus we return the memory address
of the current object
through the setters that we are doing
here we're going to return this
and after we do this we can change the
setting we are doing here to b1
statement and we can comment this out i
think we can do that and what we're
going to say is dope one and we're going
to say
set dog name and we're going to pass in
pumbaa but this is going to return a
pointer now set dog name is returning a
pointer to the current object and you
can see that here this is what we are
returning so we can go through this
pointer and call some other functions
for example we can say set dot breed
directly and the visual studio code is
going to figure out that what we are
returning is a pointer and it's going to
change our access notation here to a
pointer axis notation and we're going to
use this in one single statement so
we're going to put in our breed and
we're going to call the function to set
the age okay you see that it uses
pointer access notation and this is
really cool so we're going to put in our
four and you're going to see that this
actually works and this is really cool
if you don't want to do thanks in three
steps you can give your users the option
to do things in one step using returned
pointers like this and this is really
cool i use this all the time for my
classes that i design in my applications
so if we're both we're going to see that
the world is good and we're going to
clear and run rooster we're going to see
that the information is n name is pumbaa
breed is waterfox terrier and the age is
for and we were able to do all these
changes in one go so we can even change
this to use references here we are using
pointers so let's say that we are using
pointers but we can also use references
let's go on top here and say that this
is using pointers and we're going to
comment this out but before we do we're
going to copy all this because we're
going to need that
and we're going to
comment all this out and we're going to
go down and say change calls using
references and we're going to go down
and put in our code and we're going to
change our setters to return references
instead of pointers we can do that so
we're going to change the star here to
an ampersand symbol here and this is
going to do the magic so we have a dog
reference returned from all these
functions so because we are no longer
returning a pointer returning this
directly is going to give us a compiler
error we need to dereference this
pointer and get to what what is pointed
to now the compiler will know that we
are returning a reference to the current
object and this is the syntax we can use
to do this let's go down and dereference
all the returned pointers and if we go
down we're going to see that this is
good already and we can go down and set
up our chained call using references and
we're going to go down and say dog one
we're going to set dog name and we're
going to pass in pumbaa
what we have been doing all along now
we're going to use the dot access
notation because what we are returning
is a reference and you're going to see
that visual studio code is going to pick
this up the breed is going to be wirefox
and we're going to say set dog age and
we're going to pass in our four and
you're going to see that this is valid c
plus syntax and if we print the
information we're going to have new
information applied to our dog object
here we can weld and see that this is
actually working you see the world is
good we can clear and run rooster and
we're going to see that information has
been applied to our dog object so these
are a few examples
showing some of the usefulness for the
this pointer we have seen that we can
use the this pointer to print the memory
address of the current object if we go
down and look at our constructor and the
destructor we are printing the address
of the current object in our debug
statement here and this is really cool
we can use the this pointer to resolve
conflicts in our setters for example we
can use a parameter that has the same
name as the member variable and it's not
going to be really confusing and lead to
bad results it's going to change the
actual member variable and change it to
whatever you pass as the parameter and
this is really cool we can also use the
this pointer to set up change calls for
our function and we have seen that we
can do that either through returning
pointers like we are doing here and
using the this pointer as a return
object for our function here or we can
use returned pointers to do this and if
we do that we're going to be able to
call our functions in one go like we are
doing here using pointers or do the same
thing using references like we are doing
here this is really all we set out to do
in this lecture i hope you found it
interesting we are going to stop here in
this one the next one we're going to
learn about struct go ahead and finish
up here and meet me there in this
lecture we're going to learn about the
struct keyword and this is another
syntax you can use to create classes in
your c plus plus program we have seen
that we can already use the class
keyword to create our classes i have to
break it to you that we can also use
struct to do the same so the syntax here
is going to create a class called cat
and it's going to have a member variable
called string name the difference
between struct and class is that for
classes members are going to be private
by default and when you do something
like this and create class objects you
want to be able to access the name here
directly for example from the main
function if you do that you're going to
get a compiler error because class
members are private by default but if
you use struct members are going to be
public by default and you will have
direct access from the outside this is
the only difference between class and
struct otherwise you can use them
interchangeably and they are going to do
the same things we have been seeing for
classes they really are the same things
the only difference is that classes are
going to have private member variables
by default and struct will have public
member variables by default but we can
change this defaults by putting in our
own public and private sections inside
our class so for example here you see
that we have changed our dog class to
have a public member variable through
the public keyword here and we can do
the same for cat for example we can put
in a public section and a private
section and it's going to behave like
classes we have been welding so far
one common use we have for struct is
when we have to set up classes that only
have public member variables for example
you can need to set up a point
model in your c plus plus program and
you can set up a class like this you can
say struct point you're going to put in
the member variables and they are going
to be directly accessible from the
outside and this is something you will
see a lot out there so this is really
all about struct we're going to head
over to visual studio code and play with
us a little more okay here we are in our
working folder the current project is
struct we're going to grab our template
files and we're going to put them in
place struct that's all project here
and we're going to open this in visual
studio code
let's grab extract and drag and drop on
top of visual studio code here this is
going to open our folder we can now open
the main cpp file and clean things up a
little bit okay so we're going to set up
a simple class called dog we're going to
say class dog and inside we're going to
have a member variable called name it's
going to be an std strand let's say dog
name or m name to mean that it is a
member variable this is a syntax you
will see a lot in c plus plus out there
so let's use this from now on we're
going to say m name and we're going to
have another class let's put our
semicolon we're going to use struct to
set up another one and it's going to be
called dog let's call this cat and we
are going to go inside and set up our
member variable we're going to say std
strength m name and it's not going to
have anything m so if we create objects
of these classes and try to access them
we're going to see the fundamental
difference between structure and dog
let's create a dog and we're going to
say dog one and we're going to create a
cat and we're going to say cat one and
if we do dog 1 and try to access the m
name member variable
maybe set it to something else let's say
fluffy we're going to have a compiler
error because members of a class are
private by default and we can't really
do this
so we are trying to access something
that is private from the outside we're
going to get a compiler error okay so we
have a squiggly line here but if we try
to do the same for a cat it's going to
go through because cat is destruct and
members of structs are public by default
let's do that and really show you this
we're going to say cat1 and we're going
to say m name and we're going to give it
a name and let's say johnny i am making
this up i don't know if there is any cat
named johnny but we're going to use this
and you're going to see that we don't
have any squiggly line we're going to
build and see if gcc is going to take
this it's going to take it the world is
good we can bring up a terminal and run
the program and we're not going to see
anything because we're not printing
anything from the main function here but
if we want we can print this name of our
cat we're going to say sddc out and say
cat one name and if we build we're going
to see that so the both should be good
it is good we can clear and run rooster
and we have johnny printed out and this
is the name of volca and this is really
the difference between class and strut
members of classes are going to be
private by default members of struct are
going to be public by default but we can
change these defaults for example let's
make everything public we can do that no
big deal here
and we can move this a little bit to the
right so that things are aligned nicely
and we can do the same for struct okay
so let's align this now if we do this we
will be able to go in the main function
and say dog name and change that and
we're going to be able to see that if we
print that out so let's go down and say
stdc out and say dog1 name and print
that out
and if we build now we're going to see
the name of our dog printed out okay
well this is good we can bring this up
and clear a little bit and run rooster
we're going to see fluffy our dog name
and johnny our cat name so this is
really all about classes and struct they
are the same things but the only
difference is the defaults that come
with these things but the common use we
have for struct is when we want to set
up a class that only has direct member
variables and we don't intend to put
methods into that class a good example
of this is the struct off point so
suppose we want to model points in our c
plus plus program so we can do something
like this and a point is going to have
two coordinates x and y we're going to
say double y and from this point on we
will be able to create point objects and
print them out however we want so for
example we can go down and say point
point one and from this point we can go
in and say 0.1 and say x and assign a
value to x let's put in a 10 and we're
going to go down and say point 1 y and
we're going to give it a value let's put
in
55.5 why not and we can do whatever we
want with this point for example we can
set up a function which is going to
print a point we can do that let's say
void print point and we're going to pass
the point by value or we can even use
references because this is going to be
an object const point reference i think
this is going to do and we're going to
go inside and print the information
we're going to say
hddc out point and we're going to put
the coordinates on we're going to say x
is going to be point x and y is going to
be point y why not and we're going to
put in our closing square bracket and
we're going to say stdndl
to put a new line character after our
print here now we can go down and say
print point and pass on point one
and if we do that we're going to build
and we're going to do that through gcc
you see the both is good now if we print
we should see the information about our
point and we see point x 1 y
55.5
and we see
point x is 10 y is 55.5
we can go down and change the
information about our point for example
we can copy this and go down and change
x to
40.4
and y to
2.7 why not and if we print the
information about our point we're going
to see that we have new information and
we're going to print point one and
therefore world we're going to see the
new information so the build is good we
can clear and run rooster now you see
new information in our point so this is
really the difference between class and
struct the only difference is going to
be in the defaults and struct is mostly
useful if you want to set up classes
that only have public member variables
and you don't really want to use
functions or methods in that class and
we have an example of that here and if
you have a case like that you will use
struct your code is going to be much
easier to read and understand from the
perspective of other c plus plus
developers we are going to stop here in
this lecture and the last one we're
going to learn about the size of objects
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about sizes of class objects and try to
think about it
what are we going to see if we try to
print the size of our class here called
wrapper inside we have two member
variables which are of and type
and we have a member variable which is
of std string type what do you think
we'll see
when we print the size of this wrapper
object here
try to think about it so what c plus
plus does it's going to only account for
the size of your member variables so
it's going to add to the sizes of these
guys in memory so we know an end is
going to take four bytes in memory so
we're going to have eight bytes for
these two ants and we're going to have
an unspecified amount of memory for a
strength because a strength is
internally implemented as a class and it
stores its data as cost car pointers so
we have really a pointer
and the size of an object doesn't really
account for thanks you are referring to
using pointers it may count to the size
of the pointer itself but it's not going
to count what is pointed to and in the
case of string for example we really
want to know
the range of things that we are pointing
to so we're not going to have correct
information with hdd string here but in
general the size of an object is going
to be the sum of the sizes of its member
variables the functions are not going to
be counted then the functions are just
helper functions that live somewhere in
memory but they're not going to be
accounted for in the size of your object
another reason you might think functions
are not accounted for in the size of the
object is that really functions are
affiliated with the class itself
functions are not affiliated with class
objects the class is going to be the
blueprint from which we're going to
generate thousands of objects if we want
but the functions or the methods are
going to be associated to the blueprint
itself so it really wouldn't make sense
to associate the size of those functions
in memory to class objects now that you
have this idea let's head over to visual
studio code and play with this a little
more okay we have saved that the size is
mostly going to be the sum of the sizes
for the member variables but this is not
always correct because of a phenomenon
we called
boundary alignment
binary alignment is a thing most
compilers do when they have member
variables of different types and member
variables that have the size of four
bytes in memory are going to be stored
at memory locations that are multiples
of four and because of this phenomenon
we might have gaps between our memory if
we have variables for example that are
of two bytes in memory and four bytes in
memory and we're going to have gaps
inside and the size of the object is
going to be slightly off the sum we
might do for the sizes of our object i
realize this may be confusing we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and we're going to see a few examples
okay here we are in our working folder
the current project is size of class
objects we're going to grab our template
files pretty quick and we're going to
put them in place and we're going to
open our project in visual studio code
by dragging and dropping here we have
our main cpp file we can close the left
sidebar
and we can clean the main function here
we're going to set up a simple class
let's call this dog why not we have been
using dove so let's use this again
we're going to put our closing semicolon
we're going to put a public section and
it's going to just contain a constructor
and we're going to say dog and we're
going to use the default and we're going
to put in a private section and
in here we're going to put in a size t
and say
this is the leg count of the dog why not
let's say we are modeling this okay so
now we have our dog class in place we
can create objects of this dog class
we're going to say dog
dog one and if we do this we are
interested in knowing the size of our
dog class here
so we are going to say stdc out size of
dog and save that and uh fingers crossed
we're going to see the size of our dog
object here and try to guess what we're
going to get in the slides we have seen
that the size is mostly going to be
the sum of the size of the member
variables
and let's print the size of size t here
because size d is our only member
variable so i think it's going to be
helpful to see its size printed out
so we're going to have some context if
we do that we're going to say size of
size t and we're going to
save that and we're going to build this
program let's do that we're going to
pass this through gcc you see the both
is good
and we're going to bring up a terminal
and run this see what happens okay we
see size of size t is eight and the size
of our dark object is eight and this is
really cool because we see that the size
of our class object is really the size
of our
member variables that we have in here
let's set up another member variable and
really show you this so we're going to
have arm account okay so we are just
messing with us to learn
i don't aim for this class here to make
some sense practically we just want to
see how the member variables affect the
size of our class object now we have two
member variables and we're going to try
and world we're going to use gcc to do
that and we're going to clear and run
rooster
now you see that size of doug is 16 and
this is really
proven that the size of an object is
only accounting for the sizes of the
member variables it's not going to count
the functions that we have here so if
for example we had a function that says
printful and we have another one that
says do something this is not going to
change the size of our object because
functions aren't accounted for in the
size of our object here
so let's build and really show you this
the world is good we can clear and run
rooster we see that we have the same
sizes the size of dog is 16 the size of
size t is eight we can even use object
names here for example we are using the
class itself but we can use dog one here
and we're going to get the same
information let's both and we're going
to clear and run rooster
and you see that we have the same size
so if we change this thing to put in a
pointer we're going to see something
else let's put in an end pointer
and let's say ph like we have been doing
all along and see what we get and we
know that the size of a pointer on my
system let's print that out so that we
have no doubt let's for example say size
of end pointer is going to be size of
end pointer okay let's build we're going
to
pass this through gcc and the both is
going to be good we can clear and run
rooster we're going to see that we have
24 because we have two member variables
that are going to be eight bytes in
memory of size t they are of type size t
and we have a pointer which is going to
have a size of h in memory but we don't
care what this pointer is pointing to
if for example this pointer is pointing
to something really large
we don't care we're just going to
account for the end pointer here and
this is really phenomenal because if for
example we tried to set up an sdd string
object
and by now you should know that std
strand itself is implemented as a class
in c plus plus so it's really a class
and we can print its size so let's set
up a string object here we're going to
say std strung and we're going to say
name and we're going to initialize this
with hello world okay we're going to see
something really strange here so if we
print the size of name here we're going
to say size of name and we're going to
print that let's see what we get we're
going to run
and we're going to
see the block is good and can clear and
run roaster we're going to see that size
of name is 32.
let's change the text inside our string
and see that we change accordingly
because this can really be confusing
let's say i am the king of the universe
why not and we're going to build again
let's see what we get fingers crossed
this is going to blow your mind you see
we have the same size for name even if
we are changing the text in here so what
is really happening the strength is
storing our text here as cost card
pointer
and what we have is a pointer inside and
what we probably have inside
is a member variable which is a pointer
like we have here so what we will be
accounting for in the strength class is
the size of the pointer but it's not the
size of what is pointed to okay so the
car pointer may be pointing to thousands
of characters in memory but as long as
the compiler is concerned it's just
going to use the pointer member variable
and it's going to account for it in the
size of your object hopefully you can
understand why
the size of our string objects is going
to be the same
regardless of how large is this strand
this is really something you need to
understand otherwise this is going to
throw you off as you design your c plus
plus applications and this is really all
i had to share in this lecture the size
of your object is mostly going to be
determined by the
member variables you have and the size
is going to be the sum of the sizes of
your member variables i would like to
welcome you in this new chapter where
we're going to be learning about
inheritance and inheritance is a feature
that c plus plus provides
to allow us to build classes in terms of
other classes
and what i mean here is that we can
build complete hierarchies of classes
that depend on other classes for example
if we think of a person as a type we can
have different types of persons we can
have a doctor a doctor is a person we
can have a physician a physician is a
person we can have an engineer an
engineer as a person we can have really
all kinds of persons and we can capture
these kinds of relationships in c plus
plus using inheritance for example here
we have an inheritance hierarchy we can
set up a person type in our c plus
program and put in whatever member
variables we need to define a person for
whatever purposes we are building our c
plus plus application for once we have
this type we can build other types that
depend on this person for example we can
build an engineer type which is really
going to embody the person type inside
so what we will be doing is really
setting up a layer of a person type and
in our engineer type which is going to
depend on person we will boil the novel
layer on top of that and really reuse
that person type without having to
rebuild this from scratch hopefully you
can see that this is going to improve
code reuse we can also reuse this
engineer type and well the other types
on top of it for example we can have a
civil engineer we can have an electrical
engineer we can have all kinds of crazy
engineers modeled in our c plus plus
program
using the inheritance and this is going
to be really cool so this is what we are
going to be exploring in this chapter
looking at the facilities that c plus
plus provides to capture these kinds of
relationships in our c plus plus
programs please note that inheritance is
a really big feature and it is a
defining feature of object oriented
programming c plus plus object oriented
programming is a paradigm or a way of
thinking about programming that uses
objects and the most basic defining
feature of object oriented programming
in c plus plus is classes that we have
learned about using classes we can
define things for example we can set up
a car we can set up a house we can set
up a spaceship we can do all kinds of
crazy things with classes and ziplocs
plus inheritance is going to build on
top of classes and allow us to build
classes that depend on each other and
will the complete inheritance
hierarchies that are going to make our
design much easier to look at and
understand and work with okay so this is
what we are up against in this chapter
learning about inheritance and really
exposing you to as much as possible to
let you use inheritance in an easier way
in your c plus class programs we are
going to start in the next lecture and
try out inheritance for the first time
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to try
out inheritance for the first time in
this course
but before we do that let's remind
ourselves of what inheritance really is
inheritance is a feature we have in c
plus plus
to be able to build new classes in terms
of the classes we have predefined
and the new classes are going to be
stealing features from the already
pre-existing classes if i can say it
like that and the more classes we build
in terms of others we're going to end up
with what we call an inheritance tree
which is basically going to go from the
top to the bottom with the most
fundamental class on top and the derived
class at the bottom here we have a
simple example for example we can have a
person class
and this class may be
defining the basic features of a person
but based on that personal class we
might want to derive other classes that
build on top of this person class for
example we might want to define an
engineer and a doctor and we know that
an engineer is also a person so they are
going to inherit some features from the
person class the same goes for the
doctor class it is going to inherit
some features from person but all these
derived classes are also going to add
their own features to the person class
siplus plus allows us to build these
kinds of relationships
here is another simple example we have a
vehicle class to the top of our
inheritance hierarchy and below this
class we might derive a track class
which is also a vehicle we might have a
minivan we might have a truck we might
have a pickup truck we may really do all
kinds of crazy vehicles which are going
to inherit the basic features from the
vehicle class and add their own
specialization
on top of the vehicle class so this is
the basic idea behind inheritance in c
plus plus so the examples we're going to
do in this lecture
so here is a simple example of what
we're going to do in this lecture we're
going to set up a person class which is
going to be our base class
it is going to be defining two member
variables which are going to be of std
string type we're going to have a last
name for the person and the first name
for the person
we are going to derive from this class
and set up a player class
the player class is going to inherit
these features from the person class so
it is going to have a last name and a
first name built into it but that's
going to be our base or our starting
point we are going to add to this base
and add another member variable from
player and we're going to be having the
player class which is really a person
but it is going to add things to person
to customize on what we can do with a
player
that we wouldn't originally be able to
do or have with a person class this is
the basic idea okay now that we know
this we're going to set up our personal
class which is going to be our base
class it is going to have our two member
variables first the name and last name
we're going to have a bunch of
constructors and we're going to have a
stream output operator to be able to
print this on the console and see our
information here nothing special but now
that this class is done we can build
other classes on top of this class so
what we can do for example we can derive
a player class
so the syntax is what you see here we
say class player we say column column
and then we say public
and specify the class that we are
inheriting from so the parent class for
this class is going to be person or in
other words we're going to be deriving
from the person class and we're going to
be doing that publicly okay for now i
don't want you to worry too much about
this public keyword we're going to be
learning this in steps just know that
this is the syntax you use to derive
from another class
now the moment we do this the player
class is going to have the person
information embedded inside but we will
also have the ability to customize or
add other things
at the level of the player class this is
what we do we have a private member
variable and it is going to specify the
game at the player place we're going to
have our own set of constructors we can
really build player objects but they are
going to have a person part inside that
is going to store information about this
player person
you notice we don't have a member
variable here for the first name we
don't have a member variable here for
the last name but that information is
going to be baked into this player
object and this is really how
inheritance helps us out we can derive
from classes
and build on top of them without having
to redo the fundamental work to build
our base classes we can just build on
top of them and really do things faster
and more efficiently okay so here are a
few things you need to know about the
public inheritance that we just did and
we are saying public inheritance because
of the syntax we used here
public person this is doing public
inheritance and we're going to see what
this gives us so with public inheritance
derived classes can access and use
public members of the base class
but the derived class can't directly
access private members from the base
class i want you to let this sync end
what this means from the player class we
can't directly access the private member
variables we had in person remember our
first name and last name are private to
person and we can't directly access them
in any deriving class that is doing
public inheritance okay so in our player
class if we try to access the first name
and the last name we're going to have
compiler errors because we can't
directly access them but not to worry
here we can still go through
the public getters that we have in the
person class
to access the private member variables
from the base class and that's what
we're going to do in this lecture here
because we don't have access to more
powerful tools we're going to learn
about in the next few lectures the same
is also going to apply to friends of the
derived class
they are going to have access to private
members of the derived class but they
don't have access to
the private members of the base class if
you try to access the private parts of a
base class
from a friend of the derived class
you're going to have a bunch of compiler
errors
okay now that you know this we're going
to head over to visual studio code and
play with this a little more and really
drive this home
here we are in our working folder the
current project is first try on
inheritance we're going to grab our
template files and put them in place
let's do this
and we are going to open this in visual
studio code pretty quick by dragging and
dropping here let's do that properly and
we're going to have our main cpp file we
can clean this up a little bit and we're
going to add our classes the first class
we're going to add is the person class
so we are going to create its header
file and let's do the cpp file i am
going to grab the code i have lying on
my drive for the header here i am going
to put the class in we are including the
classes we're going to need we need
string and io stream here because we're
going to be outputting thanks through
the output stream operator
and down here we have our two member
variables we have first name and last
name they are of std string type and we
have a bunch of constructors here a
default constructor and one that takes
two parameters we are taking them by
copy here this is bad we should at least
pass them by reference here let's
correct this
pretty fast
and we're going to make the second one a
reference as well let's do this and we
have a destructor which is going to do
nothing because we really aren't doing
any dynamic memory allocation here we're
going to head over to the cpp file and
put in the code for that we're going to
include the person and we're going to do
our constructors put in the
implementations i should say and we're
going to pass our parameters by
reference again let's do this and our
constructor should be done now we have a
person class that we can use to derive
other classes and use this class as a
foundation to build other classes to
visualize this again our class person is
going to be the base class for our
player class
so if we build a player class it's going
to have
a person part of it which is going to be
the foundation on top of which we're
going to build notice that in player we
don't need to set up last name and first
name they are going to come from our
personal part of player all we need to
do in player is set up the game member
variable to make him a full player who
can have the game they happen to be
playing this is the idea here okay so
now that we know this we're going to put
in our player class we're going to
create the files for it let's do player
dot h we're going to put this in and
we're going to do player
that cpp we're going to put him and
we are going to hop over to the header
file and put in our code the class is
going to be player and it is going to be
inheriting from person this is the
syntax again we say colon colon we say
the kind of inheritance we want to do in
this case it is public and then we say
the class that we are going to be
inheriting from from this point on the
player class is going to have a person
part of it and we are going to prove
this in a minute when we run this code
here notice that we can build player
objects by just passing in the game
parameter here which is going to be used
to initialize our member variable let's
also make it a reference because this is
good practice it is going to avoid
copies you can even use string views but
that's going to be your choice
we are going to hop over to the cpp file
and put in our implementation
and this is going to complete our setup
for the player class which is going to
be inheriting from our person class here
we can actually head over to the main
cpp file and include the player class
let's do this we're going to say player
and we can create player objects let's
look at the code again for a player we
have a constructor which is going to
take a string parameter we can use this
to create a player and specify the game
they are going to be playing
but
for now we don't have enough tools to
put in the data that would initialize
the member variables in the base class
which is person here if we go back to
person we're going to see that we have
the first name and the last name
but in our player class
these member variables are going to be
inherited because a player is inheriting
from a person this is the syntax to do
that but even if the player class has a
person part inside of it we can't really
access private members from person
from a player object we're going to see
a few ways we can get around this and
one of those is to go public methods
from the person class to access
private parts of the person class this
is going to give us access to these
member variables if you go down in our
stream output operator you're going to
see that we are using these getters here
the parameter is a player objects that
we want to print out but to get access
to the names we are getting the first
name and the last name through our
getters here before we really explore
this any further i think it is a good
idea to go in the main cpp file and
create a player object so we're going to
do that we're going to say p1 and we're
going to specify that they play
basketball why not okay so we have our
player object
and we can really do all we want with
that for example we can print the
information about this player object if
you remember in player we have a stream
output operator which is going to print
all the information
and here we have a problem because this
guy is taking the data by reference
and this is not a reference this is a
temporary object that we are passing
here
so we could go back and change this to
take a string view parameter
let's go back and do that we're going to
include a string view here in player and
we're going to change our parameter to
be std string view by value and we're
going to do that in the cpp file let's
do that we're going to say std string
view and this should take care of our
problem here you see that the problem
goes away now that we have this guy we
can print it out we can say sddc out
player and i put the information out
okay so now that we have this we cannot
try and build our program we're going to
use gcc
our favorite compiler and you're going
to see that we have a problem undefined
reference to player destructor let's go
back in the header and see that we have
a destructor but we probably didn't put
a destructor in the cpp file so let's do
that or because we're not doing any
dynamic memory allocation we can even
completely take out this destructor and
we're just going to use the one the
compiler generates for us this is going
to be
much easier to handle in our code so we
can build again with gcc okay the world
is good we can run this program
and let's see if we have a powershell
window we don't we're going to bring up
a new one and we're going to run rooster
we should see information about our
player so player the game is basketball
the names are mysterious person because
that's the default data we inherit from
a person if you go back to person you're
going to see that
the default data in first name is
mysterious the default data in last name
is person and it is what we see printed
out here
in our powershell window when we print
information about our player object
another thing i want you to see is that
we can actually really prove
that any player object is going to have
a person part of it
backed in and that's going to be storing
the information that is modeled into our
person class and we can use a debugger
to do that for this to work i am going
to put a break point here on line 8
which is printing things out
this break point is going to be hit
after our object is set up and we can
really see the data inside this guy here
so what we're going to do we're going to
hit this run tab
and we're going to use g plus plus we're
going to use the debugging tools that
come with gcc because this is our
favorite we're going to hit the green
button here
this is going to start our debugging
session a binary is going to be built
and it is going to be plugged into our
debugger and we're going to hit a break
point here
now if you look on the left here you're
going to see a title that says locals
we're going to expand this and we're
going to see that the p1 object actually
has a person part of it and you see that
visual studio code is being helpful here
it is saying that this is the base class
and if we expand we're going to see that
we have our member variables we have
first name and last name and this is a
player object that we are looking at
don't forget that and on top of our
person part we also have our own member
variable which is the game that we play
and it is right here hopefully this
proves to you
that any derived class object is going
to have a base part embedded into it and
that's going to be the foundation on top
of which the derived class is going to
be building its own tank this is the
basic idea here okay now that you've
seen this we're going to kill our debug
session
and we're going to see some of the
things you need to be careful about when
doing public inheritance like we are
doing here the first thing i want you to
see is that you don't have access to
private parts
of the base class if you go back to
person here
let's kill this so that you're not
confused if we go back to our personal
class we're going to see that our first
name and last name are private
so they want to be accessible to any
class
that does public inheritance like we are
doing here they are just going to be
private they are going to be part of the
class but the derived class would have
access to them this is the idea here and
if we go in our output stream operator
and comment out what we have here and
try to directly access these member
variables let's do that i am going to
copy the code here and put that on top
and we are not going to go through the
getter methods from the base class we
are going to try and access m first name
let's go back and look at the names for
the member variables it is first name
and last name let's use that we're going
to say first name you see that through
intellisense but trying to access that
is going to give us squiggly lines you
see that we have this in our
autocomplete but we have squiggly lines
we can't access these if we try to
compile our program let's do that again
we're going to use gcc and we are going
to get compiler errors and the compiler
errors are basically going to say
first name is private within this
context again the meaning is that
first name is private to the base class
and we have no business accessing that
in a derived class which is
the player class here this is the
meaning so we can't really access that
okay i realize this is a global function
but even if we try to do that from a
member function let's do that from
a constructor we're going to try and say
first name okay i realize the access we
are trying to do from the output stream
operator is really not a good example
because this is not a member function it
is a global freestanding function so we
can try and change the first name and
last name from the constructor for
example and we're going to see that this
is not going to work either so we can
take this out and we're going to
remove our block comma so we're going to
take out what we just did here
and we're going to uncomment our good
code here which is using getter member
functions from the base class and we're
going to try and change
the first name and last name from the
base class and change those into our
constructor of the derived class we're
going to try and change for example the
first name and make it john and we're
going to take the last name and change
that to
snow let's do that and let's go back and
make sure we have the correct names
and you see that we have squiggly lines
we can't really do this because these
are private members of the base class
and we can't access them from a derived
class they are part of the player class
which is a derived class but we don't
have access to them we can't modify them
or do anything we can't read from them
we can't write from them this is the
message here if we try to build our
program we're going to use gcc to do
that
we are going to get compiler errors and
uh let's see the compiler error we get
again the error is that first name and
last name are private to the base class
and we have no business accessing them
from a derived class like we have here
so if you need any kind of access to a
private
member of the base class you will have
to go through
something that is public and a good
example is getter methods which are
going to allow you to
change things so for example if we want
the ability to change the first name and
the last name we can set up a bunch of
setter methods let's do that we're going
to say setters and we're going to say
void
set
first name and we are going to pass an
std strength view
let's do that we're going to say string
view here fn for first name
this is going to modify our class so we
are not going to mark this as a custom
member function and we're going to say
first name
equals
fn this is going to do
we are going to set up a setter for the
last name set and we're going to pass a
string view here and we're going to say
ln for the last name again this is not
going to be a cast member function so
we're going to say last name and we can
pass in ln as our new name here now that
we have these end we can take out
these things we have in the constructor
i think the job for this is done and
this is going to give you compiler
errors and we can go in our main cpp
file and change the names for this
person here for example we can say p1
set
first name we're going to pass john and
we can also set to the last name we're
going to say p1 set
last name and we're going to pass snow
and this is going to do if we build and
run this program we're going to see that
the world is going to be good this is
the first step
and if we run we should see the
information printed out we want to join
snow printed out and the game should be
basketball
let's clear and run rooster we're going
to see that the data is in here the name
the names are jon snow and we have our
game to be basketball here but notice
these are base methods and we are
calling them from a derived object and
this is living proof that the public
members from the base class are going to
be inherited and usable
from a derived class that does public
inheritance like we are doing here and
this is really the main message you can
inherit publicly and have access to
public stuff from the base class and use
them in your derived class but private
data is going to still be private to the
base class you can't use that in a
derived class this is the message here
and this is really all i wanted you to
see in this lecture the big thing is to
notice the syntax you use to do
inheritance and if you do this the
player class is going to be derived from
person
and it will have a person part
baked inside and we can build on that
foundation and for example put in our
own member variables and do all kinds of
crazy things
public stuff from the base class are
going to be inherited and usable from a
derived class we just saw that by
setting up a bunch of setters that live
in the public scope of the base class
and they were usable from the outside
because they will be inherited as public
in a derived class so we can really call
these methods and use them from the
outside like we are doing here but
private data from the base class is not
going to be accessible and usable from a
derived class and we saw that by setting
up this piece of code in the constructor
of player this is going to give us a
compiler error saying that first name
and last name are private to the base
class we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
learn about another kind of access
specifier we have in c plus plus and
that is protected
so go ahead and finish up here and meet
me there
in this lecture we're going to learn
about the protected access specifier you
can use in your c plus plus class
and we're going to be reusing the same
example from the last lecture we're
going to have a person class which is
going to act as our base class and we're
going to be deriving from this person
and creating a new class called player
the player class is going to have a
person part baked in
and we can use this as a foundation to
build other fans in player class for
example we can set up our own member
variables and do all kinds of crazy
things and this is the setup we used in
the last lecture we set up a person
class and our members were private as
you saw here but in the last lecture we
saw that
private member variables are not going
to be accessible and usable from derived
classes that do public inheritance and
sometimes we want members from the base
class to at least be accessible and
usable from a derived class but still be
inaccessible from the outside and we can
achieve this using the protected access
specifier so for example we can change
the access specifier of our member
variables from private to protected and
at the moment we do this we will be able
to access for example read from and
write into these member variables from
derived classes so for example we will
be able to modify these guys from a
constructor of the derived class and we
thought that that was impossible from
the last lecture but still we want to be
able to use these from the outside of
our derived class which is person here
so we're going to still do public
inheritance like from the last lecture
but now that our member variables in the
base class are protected we will have
the ability to do whatever we want with
them in the derived class and when we
say in the derived class we mean from
any method from the derived class for
example we can go in our constructor
here and then set data into the member
variables from the base class and that's
going to work as we're going to see
in a minute now that you know this we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and play with this a little more okay
again our member variables from the base
class are going to be protected
okay so we can really say that here
let's say protected and at the moment we
do this they are going to be accessible
and usable from a derived class so from
the derived class we will have the first
name for example
so from the derived class we will have
our members baked then we will have a
last name and the first name and because
they are protected in the base class and
we are doing public inheritance we will
be able for example to set data into
these member variables from a derived
class and that's going to be
really cool now that you know this we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and play with us a little more okay so
here we are in our here we are in our
working folder the current project is
protected members we're going to grab
the code from the last lecture and reuse
that because that's going to have our
inheritance hierarchy already set up we
will have our person and player class
and we can reuse them we will have our
person and player classes and we will
reuse them without needing to completely
set them up from scratch that's going to
save us a few seconds so we're going to
put them in here
and we are going to open this little guy
in visual studio code by dragging and
dropping here and we will have our
person class which is going to be the
base class it's going to have our member
variables which are going to be private
from the last lecture we will have a
player class which is going to be
inherited publicly from the player
we will have a player class which is
going to be publicly inheriting from
person and we have our main cpp file
which is going to set up a player object
and try to use it and we're going to see
how this goes in this lecture so what we
want to do is to change the access
specifier in the base class and make
that protected we can do that we can say
protect it and this is going to change a
few things about this class what this is
going to do
if you do public inheritance from this
person class you will have the ability
to do whatever you want with these
member variables from a derived class
you will have the ability to write into
these member variables and change the
data that we have inside you will also
have the ability to read from them and
that's something we couldn't do from the
last lecture and this may come in handy
sometimes another thing you should know
is that these members are still not
going to be accessible from the outside
so from the standpoint of the main
function for example here they are going
to behave as if they are private because
they want to be accessible from the
outside they will only be accessible and
modifiable from derived classes
that do public inheritance this is
really important to understand now that
we have this we can really do all kinds
of crazy things for example we can go in
our constructor of player and comment
what wasn't working from the last
lecture and this is going to work now so
let's uncomment this and we're going to
see that the squiggly lines are going to
go away and if we build a player object
using this constructor we're going to
see that we're going to have jon snow in
even if we don't set using the setters
from the base class so we can take these
out
and if we print information about this
player we're going to see the game to be
basketball and the names are going to be
john snow because we are setting up this
in the constructor of player that's no
longer that's no longer going to be the
data we get from the constructor of a
person object which was here
in the base class let's try to build and
run this program so that you can really
see this i just used clan here but it is
also going to work no big deal here the
build is going to be good we can clear
and bring up a powershell window we can
use to run this program we're going to
say rooster and you're going to see that
player is going to be
having the information the game is going
to be basketball the names are going to
be jon snow and we are setting this data
from a derived class and we have the
ability to do this because these members
are now protected in the base class so
they are accessible and usable from a
derived class
now that we have this ability we can
really change how our class at least the
derived class works we're going to
change it to have two more parameters
and we're going to pass the first name
and the last name and pass this data
back into the base class by setting the
data in the body of the constructor this
is going to work so let's add our
parameters we're going to say std string
view
and this is going to be
first name param and we're going to put
in another one which is going to also be
a string view parameter and it's going
to be last name param we can say that
and we're going to hop over in our
implementation let's grab what we just
added because we will need to put that
in our cpp file we are going to go in
player.cpp and we're going to add this
data we're going to put that here
we can close the left sidebar to have
some more breathing room and then we're
going to not do
an initializer list here because this is
really going to be useless we are
changing data in the body anyway so what
we can do
is say game param or a game and we're
going to say
gamipuram i am really sorry i am not
following the same convention for the
naming of my member variables but we can
change this later so let's say first
name we are going to pass in first name
ram and for the last name we're going to
say last name param and that's going to
do now we have the ability to go in the
main cpp file and create player objects
and specify the first name and the last
name and this is going to be much more
flexible so let's go back to the
constructor and see the order of our
parameters game first name last name so
we can come here and say first name is
going to be
john and the last name is going to be
snow and if we build and run we're going
to see the information printed out here
and now we have the flexibility to be
able to specify this
in a constructor and this is going to
make the job of building our objects
much easier and we can forward this data
back into the base class using the
protected mechanism that we just learned
about in this lecture and this is really
cool so let's build we're going to pass
this through gcc and the world is going
to be good we can clear and run rooster
we're going to see that the data is
passed back to the base class this is
working
really well okay so this is really all i
wanted you to see in this lecture we can
set up protected member variables and
they are going to be accessible and
usable from any derived class that does
public inheritance but they want to be
accessible from the outside so if you
try and for example say p1 and say
first name and try to change that to
something else let's say daniel for
example you're going to have compiler
errors because this is not going to work
so let's try and build and show you the
compiler error okay so protected members
are not accessible from the outside
they will be just accessible from
derived classes or to be more specific
they are going to be accessible from
the members of the derived class and by
members i mean member functions because
that's where you will be accessing and
modifying stuff so let's go back to the
main cpp file and remove this
and this is really all i wanted to share
with you and i hope you found this
lecture interesting we are going to stop
here in this one
and in the next one we're going to zoom
in on the syntax here we are using to
derive from other classes we just did
the public inheritance here but in the
next lecture we're going to see that it
is possible to actually do protected and
private inheritance and we're going to
see what this means in the next lecture
so go ahead and finish up here and meet
me there in this lecture we're going to
learn about base class access specifiers
and in case you didn't know we have been
using base class access specifiers in
this chapter all along and to really
understand this let's look at our player
class which is inheriting from person
and we are doing public inheritance the
public keyword here is a base class
access specifier and it is going to
control
how accessible our base class members
from a derived class and we have three
options okay so if we do public
inheritance like we see here in our
player class
anything that is public in the base
class is also going to be public you see
m1 here is also public in the derived
class
anything that is protected is going to
stay protected and anything that is
private in the base class is also going
to stay private in the derived class
try and take a moment to look at this
again
the member access specifiers we have in
the base class are going to stay intact
if we do
public inheritance again anything that
is public in base is going to be public
and derived anything that is protected
in base is going to be protected and
derived and anything that is private in
base is going to be
private in derived this is one kind of
inheritance we can do in c plus plus but
we can also do protected inheritance and
the syntax to do that you just use the
protected keyword here you say class
player column column and specify that
you want to do protected inheritance and
then you specify the base class you want
to inherit from the moment you do this
anything that is public in the base
class is going to be protected in the
derived class
anything that is protected is going to
stay protected anything that is private
is going to be private
and in one way you can see that we can
use these base class access specifiers
to constrain
the access specifier in derived class
but we can't make the access specifiers
in derived class
more relaxed we can only make things
more constrained or more restricted for
example the m1 member variable was
public but now we have made it become
protected by using the protected base
access specifier here okay so now you
know that we can do public and protected
inheritance but it is also possible to
do private inheritance and you do that
by using a private base class access
specifier the moment you do this
anything that is public in the base
class is going to become private in the
derived class anything that is protected
in the base class is going to become
private in the derived class and
anything that is private is going to
stay private in the derived class and
again you see that this is going to
constrain thanks things that were public
are now private in derived and we can't
really do anything with them from any
other class that might derive from our
player class so this is the setup we
have okay to sum this up through the
base class access specifier we can
control how relaxed or constrained
is the access to base class members from
the derived class and this is really
important to understand if you want to
say as relaxed as they are in the base
class you can use public inheritance if
you want to constrain a little bit you
can use
protected inheritance and things are
going to be inherited as protected
except for the private data in the base
class if you want things to be super
constrained you can use the private
inheritance that we just learned about
and everything in your derived class is
going to be private and you can use this
if it makes sense for the application
you are designing and you can use these
kinds of features if they make sense for
whatever application you are designing
with c plus plus one thing you should
know though is that regardless of the
base class access specifier we use
private members of the base class can
never be accessible from a derived class
so anything that is private is going to
stay private and you have no way to
relax things a little bit that's not
going to work you should really know
this now that you know these kinds of
inheritances we can do in ziplus plus
we're going to head over to the next
lecture and play with them a little more
in this lecture we're going to play with
the base class access specifiers we
learned about in the last lecture in
other words we're going to play with
public protected and private inheritance
in visual studio code so let's review a
little bit what we talked about in the
last lecture we say that we can have
public inheritance and the syntax to do
that is what you see here and at the
moment you do this what was public in
the basic class is going to be public in
the derived class what was protected is
going to stay protected what was private
is going to become private in the
derived class in other words public
inheritance is really not going to
change the accessibility of the member
variables we have in the base class
we're going to inherit the data as it
was with the same access level we had in
the base class this is a defining
feature of public inheritance in c plus
plus we can also do protected
inheritance and what this is going to do
is to make protected the highest access
level we can have in the derived class
so anything that was public in the base
class is going to become protected
anything that was protected is going to
stay protected because that's the
highest level we can do now
and anything that was private in the
base class is going to be private in the
derived class we say private in the
sense that it is going to be private to
the base class so you can't really use
m3 from the player class in this case if
you're trying to do that you're going to
get a compiler error okay we can also do
private inheritance and the syntax to do
that is what you see here and now
private is going to be the highest level
we can do
in the player class in terms of the
members that we get from the base class
so anything that was public is going to
become private anything that was
protected is going to become private
anything that was private to the base
class is going to stay private to the
base class this is what we mean here but
now
m1 and m2 just became public to the
player class if anybody else tries to
derive or inherit from a player these
things are not going to be accessible
and this is in some way the player class
being selfish it is saying i am going to
get everything i can from my parent
class or my base class but i am going to
make it all mine nobody else can take
this and this is the kind of setup we
can achieve
with private inheritance okay so now
that we have this in mind we're going to
play with us in visual studio code we're
going to set up a bunch of classes we're
going to set up a personal class we're
going to be inheriting from we are going
to set up a nurse class which is going
to do protected inheritance and we're
going to set up an engineer class which
is going to do private inheritance and
we're going to really play with this and
see how this plays out in real c plus
plus code so let's do this here we are
in our working folder the current
project is base access specifier a demo
we're going to do a demo on this but
before we do that we're going to grab
our template files and put them in place
and we are going to open this little guy
in visual studio code by dragging and
dropping here this is going to give us a
good starting point we're going to have
our main cpp file we're going to clean
it up and we're going to set up our base
class which is going to be the person
class so let's put this in from scratch
we're going to add our files we're going
to say person page and we're going to
say person.cpp
we are going to hop over in our header
file and put in our code nothing special
so far we have an include gourd we have
our person class it has a bunch of
member variables we have the full name
which is public we have the age which is
protected and we have the address which
is private to this class here this is
going to be our starting point
we also have a bunch of constructors we
have a default one we also have another
one which is going to take all the data
we can use the constructor person object
and here we are passing a cost string by
reference i think we can fix this and
pass a string view this is going to be
better let's say string view and we're
going to change the first parameter here
to be an std string view by value this
is going to be much better okay we have
our class we can hop over in the cpp
file and put in our implementation we
are going to change the constructor a
little bit and make sure we are taking
an std string view by value and if you
wanted to type all this code you can get
it from the resource section of this
lecture i am going to attach all the
source code and you can download and use
this however you want to really make
your learning experience as pleasant as
possible so we have our constructor here
it is going to forward the data into our
member variables the full name is going
to go into our full name member variable
we're going to grab the age and the
address and we're going to store all
this information we also have an output
stream operator which is going to be
printing all this information here it is
going to go through the getters because
we have a person object passed as a
parameter here and this is going to work
we can go in the main cpp file and
include our person class and create an
object of it we can do something like
person person one and we can pass the
data that our constructor expects we can
pass in the full name the age and the
address so let's do that we're going to
say the full name daniel gray why not
and the age is going to be 27 we can put
in whatever we want and we're going to
put in the address we're going to say
blue sky streak you can say two three
three for example and say the number of
the house to b56 why not this is a
possible address for a person so we can
say person one or we can use htdc out to
print this out because we have an output
stream operator for our person class we
can do this we're going to say person
one and we're going to put him out and
if we build and run this program we're
going to see that this is going to work
hopefully and we have a problem because
we don't have a semicolon at the end of
line 6 here let's fix that we're going
to run this task to build with gcc the
builder is going to be good we can bring
up a powershell window
and we're going to use this to run our
program if we say rooster we're going to
see that we have the person printed down
the full name is daniel gray the age is
27 the address is blue sky street 233
and the number of the house is 56 so
this is a possible implementation for
the person class but we are really not
interested in setting up a prison class
and doing things with that we are
interested in inheriting from the person
class and learn about different kinds of
base class access specifiers we can do
so we're going to set up a player class
which is going to inherit publicly from
the person class let's do that we're
going to put in our player we're going
to put in the header file let's say
player not person and we're going to say
player.h we're going to put in a cpp
file we are going to hop over in the
header of player and put in our class
let's close the left sidebar here so
that you can really see everything we
have an include guard in
we have the class player declared it is
going to do public inheritance from
person
and what this is going to do is that
anything that is public in person is
going to stay public in player anything
that is protected is going to stay
protected in player
and anything that is
private is going to stay private so we
want to be able to access private data
from a person object for example we
can't access
the address member variable here because
it is private but we can use the full
name and the age
from the
derived class
let's make sure we have a cpp file and
before we try things out
so let's hop over to the cpp file and
put in a possible implementation we are
going to include the person and player
because we're going to be using these
and we are going to set up a constructor
which is not going to do anything for a
player we also have our output stream
operator which is going to print the
data it is going to be using the getters
we have in the base class and we have
access to them
because we are doing public inheritance
so they are going to be public and we
can call them from the outside like we
are doing here notice that this is an
outside player object and we are calling
our public members on it and this is
going to work we also have a destructor
and which is really not going to do
anything but we're going to keep it in
here because it's not going to hurt so
now what we want to try out
is to see if we can access thanks from
the base class the first thing we have
in the base class is the
full name and i think we can actually
copy these blanks or we cannot just use
them m full name mh and m address we're
going to try and use them in the derived
class so let's try and say m full name
and change the full name for example to
be
daniel gray or jon snow and we're going
to
change the age to be
55 why not and we're going to try and
access the address let's see what we
called our address member variable it is
m address we can grab that and use that
in our class if we try to access that
we're going to get a compiler error
because that's going to be
private to the base class you notice
that if we even try to put some junk
data we're going to have a squiggly line
because this is not accessible here and
visual studio code is going to say that
this is not accessible
because it is private to the base class
so we can access m full name because it
was inherited as public so this is going
to be okay we can use age because it was
inherited as protected we can use it in
a derived class but we can't use the
address because it was inherited as
private and it is private to the base
class so this is not going to work even
if we try to call biola code we're going
to get a compiler error let's try to do
that so that you can really see for
yourself okay so we have a compiler
error and this was declared in the base
class as private this is what the
compiler error is saying so we shouldn't
really be doing this the derived class
has no business
modifying a private member of the base
class this is the message here so we're
going to comment this out and say that
this is going to give you a compiler
error but we are also going to create a
player object and try to access these
guys and see how accesses from the
outside so we're going to go in the main
cpp file and we're going to include
player dot h and we're going to create a
player object we can put in a separator
and say a bunch of dashes here this is
going to do i think this is going to
work and we're going to create a player
object we can say player and player and
not put any parenthesis here this is
going to call the default constructor
that we have in our player class and we
can try to use this but before we do
let's try and build and see that this is
going to build just fine we're going to
work with gcc let's do that we're going
to see that the world is good we can try
and access stuff from this player object
we can say player and say m full name
you see that this is accessible we can
actually change this
to samwell jackson we can do that but if
we try and say player mh we're going to
see that this is not accessible here
because this was inherited as protected
if we go back to person we're going to
see that the age is protected so it will
be accessible in derived classes just
like we did in our play method of the
player class but we can't access the age
from the outside of a player object
because that's not going to be
accessible from the outside this is a
defining feature of the protected access
level so this is not going to work even
if we try to build we're going to get a
compiler error along the lines of this
is not accessible in this context and it
was declared in the base class so we
can't really access it from the outside
this is the compiler error here so we're
going to comment this out and say that
this is going to give you a compiler
error okay so i hope you know that you
can't even have a chance accessing a
private member of a base class from a
derived object in the main function like
we do here so if we try and do player
and say m address this is not going to
work okay so if we try to change this
for example to some junk data this is
not going to work we're going to get a
compiler error because this was declared
private in the base class and it is
private to the base class you can't
really access it from the outside you
can't even access it from a derived
class so let alone access this on the
outside in the main function so this is
not going to work it is going to give
you a compiler error but we're going to
weld and show you the compiler error
because we are learning here so we're
going to get a compiler error that says
m address is private within the context
where we are trying to use it so we
can't really use it from the outside
here again this is going to give us a
compiler error let's say that here and
this is really what i wanted you to
learn about public inheritance anything
that is public in the base class is
going to be public in the derived class
anything that is protected is going to
stay protected and what that means it
will be usable in the derived class but
you can't use that from the outside and
anything that is private in the base
class is going to stay private so you
can't use that from the derived class
and you can't even use that from the
outside like we are doing in the main
function here this is not going to work
okay so now that we have this in place
we're going to set up another class that
is going to do
protected inheritance and that's going
to be our nurse class so we're going to
put this in let's put in a nurse header
file this is going to be nurse.h we're
also going to put in nurse.cpp okay so
we're going to head over in the header
file and put in the code for our nurse
class we're going to say cluster nurse
and say protected to mean that we want
to do protected inheritance and what
this is going to do anything that is
public in the base class is going to be
protected in the derived class which is
our nurse class anything that is
protected is going to stay protected
anything that is private is going to
stay private
to the base class this is what we mean
here okay now that we have this end we
can put in the implementation for our
nurse class and we're going to have a
constructor and we're going to have our
output stream operator and we're going
to have a destructor which is really not
going to do anything because we don't
have any dynamic memory allocation in
our class
we are going to try and build this code
to see that it is going to work we have
a squiggly line in the main cpp file but
it was because of the line 15 here and
it has been commented down let's see if
we can build this program okay you see
that the world is going to be good and
we are able
to call
thanks from our output stream operator
you see we have an earth operand we are
able to call this gateful name and get
age member function
because they are now protected in the
nurse class but we are able to call them
from the outside
because this operator is a friend of our
nurse class here i want you to say this
some of you are going to ask
aren't we using an object and calling a
method using the dot operator this
qualifies as calling thanks from the
outside and yes that's true but this
method is really like a member function
in that it has access to private and
protected data from our nurse class and
the reason is it is a friend of the
nurse class here that's why we are able
to do
something like this but what i really
want you to see now that that doubt is
cleared is the kind of access we have to
thanks from the base class we will still
be able to use m full name here because
it was inherited as protected so we can
use it from a derived class we can say m
full name jon snow this is going to work
because this was
inherited as protected now it is
protected in the eyes of the nurse class
this is what we mean here so this is
okay this is going to work we can get
the age we can use that and we can say
john's and we can say
23 for example this is going to work
because this is protected but we can't
use the address if we do that we want to
be able to change it we will get a
compiler error because
this is private to the base class this
is the same thing we saw in the last
lecture this is going to give us a
compiler error if we try to build this
program let's try and build it to really
prove this the body is going to be good
without line 17 here but if we
uncommented and trying to build the
program let's do that we are going to
get a compiler error and the compiler
error is going to say let's go up and
see if we can get this message it's
going to say
m address is private within this context
where we are trying to use it and that's
line 17 of the nurse class if we go
there we're going to find the offending
line here so we're going to comment this
out and say that this is going to give
us a compiler error okay so you
shouldn't do this now that we know
things from the inside let's see how
things fair
on the outside we are going to hop over
to the main cpp file and include our
nurse class and we're going to create a
nurse object we can go down and say
stdcl and we're going to put in our
dashes and we're going to create a nurse
object i think we have a default
constructor for a nurse we're going to
say nurse 1 and we're going to basically
try and do the same things we did for
the player object from the outside if we
try to access the full name now it's not
going to be accessible because it was
inherited
with protected access level so if we do
nurse and say m full name you're going
to see that autocomplete is not here
this is a good sign that this is not
accessible from this place if we say
davy jones we're going to get a compiler
error and if we try to build we're going
to get a descriptive compiler error at
least i hope so let's build we're going
to see that with world with errors and
if we go up we're going to have our
error nurse was not declared in this
scope did you mean nurse one yes we met
nurse one sorry for that we're going to
build again thank you gcc for pointing
this out we are going to get another
kind of error and if we look at our
error here we're going to see that m
full name is inaccessible within this
context because it is a protected member
of the nurse class now it was inherited
as protected and we can't access it from
the outside we can access that from the
inside because it is protected but if we
try to access it from the outside we're
going to get a compiler error and this
is a defining feature
of protected inheritance even things
that were public in the base class are
going to become protected in the derived
class so this is the message here and
this is going to give us a compiler
error okay so if we also try to access
nurse 1 and say m
h this is also going to give us a
compiler arrow let's try to put in an
edge here let's put in 51. you're going
to see that we're going to get the same
kind of error
let's really try these things out and
learn about every possible way we can
set up these things
if we look at the error we're going to
see that image is protected within this
context so we can't really access it so
this is the compiler error we get and i
hope you know that if you try and access
the address you're also going to get a
compiler error because that's private to
the base class so we can't even use that
from a derived class like nurse here
that's not going to work let's say that
here we have a compiler error and we're
going to set up another class which is
going to inherit privately and see how
that works out the class is going to be
engineer we're going to see that the
error here goes away so let's create our
engineer class we're going to put in a
header file that's going to be our
engineer.h we are also going to put in
cpp okay so we're going to hop over to
our header file and put in our engineer
class we're going to say engineer and
say that we want to inherit privately
from the person class this is the syntax
here and this is going to do private
inheritance and what this means is that
anything that is public is going to
become private to this class anything
that is protected in the base class is
going to become private to this class
and anything that was private in the
base class is going to stay private we
won't have access to that whatsoever in
the derived class directly we are going
to hop over to the cpp file and put in
our implementations we're going to have
a default constructor for engineer which
is not going to be taking any parameter
we're going to have our output stream
operator which is going to still work
because it is a friend of the engineer
class so all these things that were
inherited to be private are going to be
private to the engineer class and any
friend of the engineer class will have
access to that that's why we are able to
call get full name get age and get
address here and get these things to
work okay now that this is out of the
way we can try and access our thanks
we're going to try and do the same
things we did in our nurse header we're
going to copy the code because we are
trying to access the same member
variables and we're going to see how
this fairs in our engineer class this is
going to save us a few seconds
if we try to access the full name this
is going to work because it is private
to this class if we try to access the
edge this is going to work because all
these guys are now private
to this class here but if we try to
access the address this is going to give
us a compiler error because address is
private to the base class if we go back
to person we're going to see that this
is the case
and if you try to inherit from this
class in any way you're not going to be
able to change this access level this
member variable is always going to stay
private to the base class and no derived
class will be able to modify or read
from this in any way so this is the
setup we have here if we try to build
we're going to get a compiler error
let's first take this out and show you
that this is going to build
just fine without this line here
and i am going to build again and show
you that if we bring that in we're going
to get a compiler error so the build is
good we can go back in our engineer
class and bring in the offending line we
can uncomment this and if we want we're
going to get a compiler error let's make
sure you see the compiler error here so
the world was finished with errors and
if we go up we're going to see that we
have an error here and the error is
going to say m address is private within
this context and the context is what we
have at line 17 in the
engineer class so we can go there and
find the offending line and we're going
to comment this out and this is going to
give us a compiler error now you know
this but this is how things are going to
work from the inside but we also need to
look at how things fare from the outside
let's go back in our main cpp file we
are going to include our engineer class
and we are going to create an engineer
object we can go down and say sddc out
and put in a bunch of dashes to separate
on thanks and we can create a
engineer object and that's going to be
engineer one and if we try to access the
full name that's not going to work
because it is now private
to the engineer class
if we say engineer one and try to say m
full name and try to change the name in
any way and say for example
olivier godson i am making this up i
don't know if this name exists but the
point is that this is not going to work
it is going to give you a compiler error
because m full name is now private to
the engineer class it was inherited to
be private to the engineer class and if
you try to do this you're going to get a
compiler error let's try and work with
gcc to really show you this and the
world is going to be finished with
errors and if we go up we're going to
find our error
full name is inaccessible from within
this context and the offending line is
at line 27 of the main cpp file if we go
there we're going to find our line and
we're going to say that this is going to
give us a compiler error so let's say
that and we can't even access the age
and the address member variables the age
is also going to be private to engineer
but the address is private to the base
class
so that's not going to work either so we
can't really access that from the
outside because it is now private to the
engineer class so let's go down and
really show you that we're going to go
down and say engineer one and say mh if
we try to do that that's not going to
work that's going to give us a compiler
error and if we try to build we're going
to get a compiler error along the same
lines as what we just got here
the book is going to finish with errors
and if we look at our error we're going
to see that mh is protected within this
context so we can't use it at line 28 of
the main cpp file this is going to give
us a compiler error let's do that we're
going to say that here and if we try and
access the m address member variable
that's not also going to work because
this is even more restricted for access
it is private to the base class so we
can't access it from a derived class
directly we can't even access that from
the outside so you should really know
this so if we put in some junk data here
and try to build this is going to give
us a compiler error that says that this
is not accessible from the main cpp file
like we are trying to do on line 29 here
so we're going to get an error and the
error is going to say m address is
private within this context and the
offending line is at 29 of the main cpp
file we're going to take this out and
we're going to say that this is going to
give us a compiler error this is really
all i wanted you to see in this lecture
and before we wrap this up let's try and
build again and make the error go away
because i don't like to leave you with
code that has compiler errors and the
book is good and this is really all i
wanted you to see in this lecture that
you can do all kinds of inheritances in
your c plus plus code you can do public
inheritance you can do protected
inheritance you can do private
inheritance and we had a chance to look
at all these scenarios in this lecture
here the message is the same as we saw
in the last lecture if you do public
inheritance anything that is public in
the base class is going to stay public
in the derived class anything that is
protected is going to stay protected
anything that is private is going to
stay private and this is really
misleading in a way the private data
from the base class is not going to be
private to the derived class it's going
to stay private to the base class so if
you try to use this in any way from the
derived class you're going to get
compiler errors because you can't access
that even if it is part of you player
has a person part of it but it can't
access private members from the base
class you should really know this we
have seen that we can also do protected
inheritance and that's going to
constrain events to have
the highest level of access to be
protected so anything that is public is
going to be stripped down to protected
access anything that is protected is
going to stay protected anything that is
private is going to be private to the
base class you should really make this
super clear we can also do private
inheritance as we saw and this is going
to strip down the highest level access
to be private so anything that is public
is going to be constrained to be private
anything that is protected is going to
be inherited as protected to the player
class but anything that was private in
the base class is going to stay private
to the base class even the player class
won't have access to this member
directly if we really need access to
private data from the base class we
might go through public getters or
anything we get from the base class but
we can't access m3 directly and use it
from the derived class that's going to
give us a compiler error this is really
all i wanted you to see in this lecture
and i hope you find this interesting we
are going to stop here in this lecture
in the next one we're going to try and
zoom in on private inheritance and show
you some things you really need to be
careful about
so go ahead and finish up here and meet
me there
in this lecture we're going to zoom in
on private inheritance and we're going
to see that the class that does a
private inheritance is really selfish
here is a simple structure we will be
using in this lecture here we will set
up a person class which is going to act
as our base class we are going to
inherit from this class privately and
create an engineer class
and what this is going to do it's going
to take everything from the class person
and make it private to the engineer
class so the m1 member variable which
was public in the base class is going to
be private to the engineer class this is
what we have here the m2 member variable
which was protected is going to become a
private in engineer that's what we have
here
and the m3 member variable which was
private to person class is going to stay
private to person in the eyes of
engineer this is the situation we have
here so the problem is going to really
show up when somebody else tries to
inherit from engineer because m1 and m2
are now private to engineer they will be
inherited but still inaccessible to the
civil engineer class here m1 and m2 will
be private to the engineer class but m3
will be private to the base class which
is person so hopefully you can see the
message that if a member variable is
private
it can't be inherited in any way it
doesn't matter which kind of inheritance
you do so starting from engineer which
has made m1 and m2 private to itself
it's no longer possible to forward these
guys down in the inheritance hierarchy
another way to look at this is to see
that the engineer class is really
selfish it is saying i am going to take
everything i can get from my parent
classes because i am
inheriting privately but nobody else
will be able to take things from me
because i'm going to make them private
to myself so even if civil engineer is
doing public inheritance
that's not going to give him any access
to these member variables which are now
private to the engineer class hopefully
you can really see this and private
inheritance is going to really constrain
what you can forward down to other
classes that are going to be inheriting
from you this is the message i am trying
to convey here okay so here is the same
example in code we have our person class
it's going to have our member variables
we're going to have the full name the
age and the address they are going to
have public protected and private access
we are going to inherit from person and
create our engineer class we are going
to privately inherit from person and
this is going to take everything we get
from person and make it private to the
engineer class and one exception is
going to be
what was already private to the base
class which is our person class here
this is going to still stay private to
the person class regardless of what kind
of inheritance you do from person but
any other thing if we have any member
variable which are public or protected
or even if we have some member functions
which are public or protected everything
is going to be private to the engineer
class because we have done private
inheritance here so if we inherit from
engineer and do any kind of inheritance
we are going to do the most relaxed kind
of inheritance which is going to keep
the kind of access we had in the base
class but this is not going to improve
anything everything is going to stay
private to the engineer class and the
civil engineer is really not going to
have any access to any member variable
or member function that is inherited
from the engineer class and we are going
to see this in a minute when we hit
visual studio code
so again if a class is doing private
inheritance it's really another way to
say this class is selfish it's going to
take everything it can from the parent
class but it's not going to forward
nothing to downstream inheritance
classes and this is the setup i really
want you to understand here and only do
private inheritance when you want this
kind of behavior now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more
here we are in our working folder the
current project is closing in on private
inheritance we're going to zoom in on
this and really understand the effects
of doing private inheritance we're going
to grab the code from the previous
lecture and we're going to grab the
engineer
and
the person class these are going to be
our starting point here make sure you
grab the dot vs code folder if you are
using vs code with this course that's
going to give you the basic settings we
need to do our c plus plus program i am
going to copy these guys down and put
these in our current project and again
make sure you have the main cpp file the
person class and the engineer class and
these are going to be our starting point
so we're going to open this little guy
in visual studio code by dragging and
dropping here we're going to look at our
main cpp program we are not going to
include nurse because we don't have this
included here
and we can really take out everything we
have in the main function we're going to
be adding our own thing here we also
don't need the player class here we're
just going to be using person and
engineer let's look at the person class
it is going to have the member variables
that we expect
we are going to have a public member
variable the full name a protected
member variable mh and a private member
variable m address here we are going to
create an engineer class which is going
to privately inherit from person
so it is going to make everything
private to itself the engineer class is
going to have a person part in at but
the member variables we get from the
person class are going to be stripped
down to private access level except for
the member variables which are already
private in the base class and that
happens to be the address so it doesn't
matter which kind of inheritance you do
the m address member variable is going
to still be not accessible to
inheritance classes this is going to
still be private to the base class which
is the person class here so the
full name is going to be stripped down
to private access level in engineer the
edge is also going to be stripped down
to private access and these are going to
be private now to the engineer class and
any class that tries to inherit from
engineer is not going to have access to
these guys so if we do any kind of
inheritance from engineer we want to
have access to full name we want to have
access to mh because these are going to
be private to this class here this is
the setup we want to understand in this
lecture so what we're going to do we're
going to set up a new class which is
going to inherit from our engineer class
and it is going to do public inheritance
and we're going to see how this works
we're going to create a civil engineer
class which is going to inherit from
engineer so let's do this we're going to
create a header file for our civil
engineer class and we're going to create
a cpp file
we are going to head over in our header
file and put in the class it's not going
to be anything sophisticated we're just
going to have in our include guard we're
going to create a civil engineer class
which is going to publicly inherit from
engineer but remember everything was
made private to the engineer class so
even if we're doing public inheritance
the full name member variable is going
to be private to engineer the age is
going to be private to engineer and
engineer won't have any access to these
guys but before we really play with that
we're going to put in our implementation
in the cpp file
so let's put in the code here we're
going to put in the implementation and
we're going to have our constructor in
place but notice what happens on our
output stream operator the output stream
operator is a friend of the civil
engineer class so it should have access
to anything we have in our civil
engineer class but notice what is
happening here
the get full name method is not working
because it has been made
private to the upstream class which
happens to be
our engineer class and we can't really
access them even if we know that they
are really part of the interface of the
person class we have them as public
members of the person class but when the
engineer class did private inheritance
it made everything that is not private
to person private to itself so these
gators are going to be private to
engineer when the engineer does private
inheritance the member variables which
are public and protected all these
things are going to be stripped down to
private access level so they are going
to be private to engineer and any kind
of inheritance you're going to do is not
going to change that they are going to
be inherited as private to the engineer
class that's why we can't even call them
from a function which is a friend of our
civil engineer class and we know that if
you mark something as a friend it's
really going to have access to anything
you have including private members but
we can't call any of the members from
the engineer class because everything is
now private to the engineer class this
is what i want you to see if you do
private inheritance this is going to
really strip down
anything from the upstream class and
make that private to the class that is
doing private inheritance this is the
message here and again if you go in any
method of the civil engineer class and
try to do any kind of access for example
calling the get full name
method is not going to board well we're
going to see that this is inaccessible
here if we try to access m full name
for example change this to be something
else let's say daniel
gray this is not going to work if you
try to access mh
and change it to 45 for example this is
not going to work we already know that
the address is private to person so we
shouldn't really try to access it
because it is inaccessible regardless of
any kind of inheritance you do but the
members that were public from person
can't be accessed from any class that is
inheriting from person even if we know
that these things are public or
protected in the person class
and this is really what i want you to
see if we try and build our program
we're going to get a bunch of compiler
errors saying that we can't access these
guys
from our civil engineer class we are
going to use the gcc compiler here
because it is our favorite and we're
going to see our compiler errors here
okay so we're going to get a bunch of
errors let's go up and see all of them
we're going to get an error saying that
getfullname is inaccessible within the
context of the c4 engineer header class
at line 13 we are calling this method
that's not going to work we have another
error here saying that the getfullname
method is not accessible from line 13 of
the civil engineer header
okay it is really the same error but if
we go down we see that we get a bunch of
other errors we have m full name which
is not accessible we have m edge which
is not accessible we can't really do
these kinds of things from the civil
engineer class because all these are
going to become private to the upstream
class that did private inheritance so
let's take this out and
show you that even if we can't access
these guys they are still part of our
civil engineer class and we're going to
use a debugger to do that i am going to
take out these things or i can comment
them out and say that they are going to
give you compiler errors i think this is
going to be more descriptive so let's
say compiler error
and access to the edge is also going to
give you a compiler error and we're
going to go down and show you that we're
also going to have the same problem in
our output stream operator so if you
really want your output stream operator
to work here what you can do is put some
public members
in the engineer class and make it give
you access to the members that were
eclipsed to private access in this class
here for example you can return the full
name you see that we can access that
here you can return the age but you
still don't have access to the m address
member variable because this is private
to the person class but i really don't
even want to do this because doing this
kind of design
is sign of bad design in the first place
so if you need to do those kinds of
getters and forward them down to
inheritance classes why not change the
design in the first place and not to do
private inheritance here for example if
you change this inheritance to protected
or public these members are going to be
directly automatically forwarded down to
any inheritance class so just know that
you can put in public getters that are
going to give access to the full name
and age but you still want to be able to
access the address member
from the inheritance class because this
is the design you achieve by marking
something as private in the base class
if you want the address to be forwarded
down you might change the access level
we have here and maybe make it protected
or public so this is the ideas i really
want you to grasp i am going to comment
out the offending code here because i
want you to be able to build this
program and see that even if we can't
access this get full name and get
address members from inheriting classes
they are still part of our interface we
just can't have access to them because
of the choices we have made in upstream
classes so what i am going to do i am
going to go in my main cpp file and i am
going to create an engineer object
i will also include civil engineer here
let's do that and i am going to create
an engineer object and i am going to
create a civil engineer object
and i am going to just say done here and
i am going to put the break point on
line 12. we are going to use a debugger
to really see
that engineer objects and the civil
engineer objects
still have a person part of them we just
can't access the interface that was
eclipsed by the engineer class so we are
going to hit the run tab here
and we are going to
start our debugging session by clicking
on the green button here
we are going to build our program and if
the build is good we're going to plug
the binary that was generated into our
debugger and we are going to hit our
break point in a minute once we hit our
break point we are going to look at the
local variables we have in the main
function we're going to see them on the
left here if we expand we're going to
see that we have an engineer one object
and we have a civil engineer one object
if we look at our engineer we're going
to see that we have a person part of
this which is our base class and if we
look at civil engineer it's also going
to have a base of engineer so any civil
engineer is also going to be an engineer
but the engineer part of the civil
engineer also has a person part of that
you should really see this information
and the main message i want to convey
here is that all these objects have a
person part of them we just can't access
that part in objects of our inheritance
classes because of the design decisions
we have made let's close this off now
that you have seen this and again
we are really working on this
inheritance hierarchy the base class is
person
and it's going to have these member
variables
but if we do private inheritance from
the person class anything that is not
public is going to be eclipsed down to
private level access so any other class
that is going to inherit from our
engineer class now is not going to have
direct access to these members because
they are going to become private to this
class here and that's the experience we
have if we try to
use any of this methods and members we
get from engineer
this is not going to work because they
are now
private to the engineer class this is
the message here so the get full name
get age
methods are not going to work if we try
to use the contract count member which
comes from the engineer class that's not
also going to work if we look in our
header and try to use any of these
members we're going to get compiler
errors because all these guys are now
private to the engineer class this is
really all i wanted to share in this
lecture let's head over to the cpp file
and comment this out again because i
don't want to leave you with these
compiler errors i hope you found this
lecture informative and fun
we are going to stop here in this one in
the next one we're going to see that we
can actually resurrect some members back
in scope
if they were eclipsed by the kind of
inheritance we did from an upstream
class
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to explore
how we can resurrect members back in
scope so what do we mean here suppose we
have our trusty inheritance tree here we
have a base class person the engineer
class is going to do private inheritance
and it's going to really be selfish and
say
i am going to take everything i can from
the upstream person class but i am going
to make everything my own and nobody
inherited from me will have access to
these guys for example m1 and m2 are
going to be private to the engineer
class
starting here when the engineer class
does private inheritance so any other
class for example civil engineer which
is inheriting from
the engineer class in any way won't have
access
to the m1 and m2 member variables so
suppose for some reason that we have
this kind of setup here but again we
want some members to be accessible to
other downstream classes
suppose for example we want the m1
member variable to still be accessible
to downstream classes while we have done
private inheritance c plus plus is
really weird in a way it is going to
work hard to really prevent you to do
thanks and that gives you a back door
you can go through to
allow the same thing you were trying to
avoid in the same place it is the same
kind of logic we have here it allows you
to use private inheritance to prevent
downstream classes to access to anything
you get from upstream classes but then
again it allows you to change that and
relax the access to downstream classes
for example we can change the access of
m1 and m2 make it more relaxed make it
public or protected if we wanted that so
let's take a look at some code because i
know that these things can really be
confusing okay we are going to start
from a person class which is going to
have a bunch of member variables we will
also have a bunch of getters that are
going to return all these member
variables and we are going to do private
inheritance from person in an engineer
class this is going to strip down access
to the members we get from person
to
private level access for example they
get full name member function the gate
age the gate address member functions
are going to be private to the
engineer class now but for some reason
you might want to resurrect them
to a more relaxed access level and you
do that using the using keyword so the
first thing you need to do is to choose
the section in which you're going to be
putting these using statements for
example because we put them in a
protected section
all these guys are going to be
resurrected with a nexus level of
protected if we put them in a public
section they are going to be resurrected
with a public access level and they are
going to be accessible from inheriting
classes one thing you should know is
that you can't resurrect
something that is already private to an
upstream class for example we know that
our m address member variable was
private to the person class so we can't
really resurrect that in an inheritance
class if we do that we're going to get a
compiler error and hopefully this is
going to drive the point home that
private inheritance is really really
serious and that it's going to strip
down access to private level access in
an inheritance class and any downstream
inheritance class will never be able to
resurrect those member variables to a
more relaxed access level so because
everything here is inherited as private
by default any downstream inheriting
class will never be able to resurrect
these guys for example to public or
protected scope this is the message here
and you can use this kind of design if
you want that but personally i don't
like to do this because it's going to
make your code much more
hard to read and understand if you want
these guys to be public or protected why
not make them public or protected in the
first place and really not use private
inheritance that's going to be much more
direct to see and understand and your
code is going to be easier to work with
for you in the future or for some other
developers that will get to work on your
code in the future so this is the
message here you can use this feature to
resurrect members back
to a relaxed access level and now that
you have an idea about this we're going
to head over to visual studio code and
play with us a little more
here we are in our working folder the
current project is resurrecting members
back in context we are going to
completely reuse the code from the last
lecture because it's going to give us a
good starting point we can copy
everything except for the binary here we
don't need that in our current project
we're going to put in our starter code
and we're going to open this little guy
in visual studio code so we're going to
have our code we're going to have our
main function and we're going to have
all these objects created here i'm
really not sure if we're going to need
this yet so let's take this out and
we're going to look at our personal
class it is going to have our members
here and we are going to have a bunch of
getters which are going to be returning
these member variables and we have a
constructor here which is really going
to build a person object nothing
complicated here we have an engineer
class which is going to privately
inherit from person and we know that
this is going to eclipse everything that
is not private in the person class to
private level access so everything is
going to be private to the engineer
class now but sometimes we don't want to
do that for example if we go down in our
civil engineer class
we're going to see that
the get full name and the getage methods
are going to be private to the app
stream engineer class and that's going
to break the code for our output stream
operator and it's not going to work
because we want to have access to get
full name and get age and that's also
going to kill access we had on the get
address method which would give us
access to the address member that we
have in our person class let's make sure
we are looking at person
i am confused here we have a lot of
pieces of code here
where is the person header
it is down here so we have the get
address method which is going to return
the address we want to have access to
that in our civil engineer class to be
able to print all this information if we
also want to print the contract count we
can go in our engineer class and put in
a method which is going to return that
so we can say end
and say get contract count and this is
going to be a const member function
because it's not going to be modifying
our object we're just going to return a
value we're going to return the contract
count and we can go in our civil
engineer implementation file and change
this to say
operand
get contract account we can do that okay
we have this method now we want this to
work this is going to work because we
are doing public inheritance from the
civil engineer class but we want this to
work we want to get full name get age
and get address to work here and we can
use the using feature to resurrect these
members to an access level which will
allow our civil engineer class to pick
them up so we can go in our engineer
class and set up for example a public or
protected scope we're going to use
protected because we want these to only
be accessible from
inherited classes for example so we're
going to say protected and we're going
to say using this is the syntax we're
going to say person and we're going to
say get full name we're going to say
using person get age going to choose
this and we are going to say using
person and say get address i think we
have that method here the moment we do
this we're going to go in our civil
engineer class you're going to see that
it is going to work now because what we
just did is resurrect these members to
have protected access level in the
engineer class so the inheritance
classes are going to look at this and
see that they have a protected access
level in the engineer class and they are
going to be forwarded down to any
inheritance class we could also change
this to public this is also going to
work they are going to be inherited as
public and hopefully you can see that
any member that you resurrect it's going
to take the excess level of the section
where you resurrect it if we resurrect
them in a public scope they are going to
be resurrected with a public access
level if we resurrect them in a
protected scope they are going to be
resurrected with
protected access level and this is the
message here now if you happen to have a
bunch of overloads in an upstream class
for example suppose we have a bunch of
add
functions in the person class we can go
in and put in let's do that we can go
down and say
double or ent let's say and that's going
to be much simpler we can say add and
say end
a and say ent b and say ent c we're
going to have
three things that we are adding this is
going to be a const member function it's
not going to be modifying our members in
any way so we're going to return
a plus b
plus c this is something we can return
from a member function here
and we're going to do an overload of the
add member
to do
the addition of two parameters so we're
going to only have a and b and i think
we can use a and b in the first
overload here that's going to be much
easier to follow so we have one that
adds two parameters
and we have another one which is going
to add three parameters if we
privately inherit from person these guys
are going to be stripped down to private
level access in the engineer class and
they want to be accessible from in any
other downstream class so for example if
we head over in our civil engineer class
and try to say add
10 to two for example we're going to get
a compiler error because we don't have
access to this but we can also resurrect
these ad members in our engineer class
so let's go there and we're going to set
up a public
section in this class here and we're
going to say using person add this is
going to resurrect all the overloads
that we have in our upstream class and
this is going to be the case because we
resurrect only based on the name of the
function
and
the same name for a member function can
be shared by many overloads so if we do
this kind of resurrecting we are doing
for the add
member function from person we are going
to get all the overloads if we go in
civil engineer we will be able to use
the member function taking two
parameters we will also be able to use
the one that takes three parameters they
are all going to be resurrected here
this is the message i want to convey if
we do this you're going to see that this
is going to work and our code is going
to just world fine let's build and see
if the build is good actually we're
going to pass this through gcc the world
is going to be good so everything is
working just fine and the message i
really wanted to convey is that it is
possible to resurrect members
in a more resurrected access level if
you are inheriting using a really
constrained base class access specifier
for example we are inheriting using a
private
access specifier this is going to
eclipse everything we get from the
upstream class to private level but if
you think that's too much and you have a
few members that you would like to put
in a more relaxed access level you can
use this resurrecting feature and it is
going to make things accessible in
downstream classes if that's what you
want in your program and again i hope
this drives the point to home that
ziploc plus is going to sometimes work
really hard to prevent you from doing
one thing and then again give you a back
door you can go through to do that same
thing this is the same thing here we are
doing private inheritance but we aren't
allowed to
kill
or
relax the effects of private inheritance
by bringing things in a more relaxed
access level and you can use this if it
makes sense for your code again i don't
like this personally because it's going
to make code confusing if other
developers see that you are doing
private inheritance they are going to
expect everything from the app stream
class to be private
to the class that is doing private
inheritance and if they see that they
can use this thanks that should be
private by default and downstream
classes this is really going to confuse
them and it is going to cost them more
minutes to look at your code to really
understand what is going on so if you
really want this dance to be accessible
in downstream classes why not do public
or protected inheritance in the first
place this is my argument here but it is
going to be your choice my job here is
to make you aware of the possibilities
that you have in the ziploc plus
programming language okay the last thing
i want you to see in this lecture is
that if there is something that was
already private in an app stream class
you can't resurrect that if you try to
do that you're going to get a compiler
error this is also going to drive the
point home that you can also resurrect
member variables so far what we have
only resurrected was all member
functions and we can also resurrect
member variables so we're going to try
and resurrect the m address member in
the engineer class and let's see how
this works out so let's go in our
engineer class we can go in our
protected section we can do this really
in any kind of section we're going to
say using and we're going to say person
and we're going to say m address you see
that this is not going to be
available in autocomplete this is going
to be a sign that this is going to give
us a compiler error and if we're trying
to do that we're going to see that we're
going to get a compiler error the
message here is that if something is
already private in a nap stream class
you can't resurrect it it is it claps
down
forever
and hopefully this drives the point home
again that private inheritance is really
serious for example in our civil
engineer class we can't resurrect
something that was already eclipsed to
private level access by the engineer
class let's go in our personal class and
see if we have any other member function
we can
play with we're going to put in a member
function that says do something we're
going to say void
do something and it's going to be
constant it's just going to say hello we
can do something like this we are
learning
and this method is going to be eclipsed
down to private level access because we
are doing private inheritance from
person let's go back in our engineer and
comment this out because it is going to
give you a compiler error if you build
you're going to get
a weird compiler error i think i should
really show you this because we are
learning here so we're going to try and
build our program anyway we're going to
pass this through gcc
and we're going to see the kind of
compiler error we get
and we are going to see that there's no
member std this is a problem we just
introduced in our class here i think to
solve this problem we can just put our
definition in the cpp file we can do
that we're going to grab this and we're
going to put the definition in
person.cpp because we have io stream
included in there this is going to make
our code work much better let's do this
we're going to say void and say person
and we're going to say sddc out hello
this is going to fix our problem here
and the only problem we will have will
be in engineer
where we are trying to access things
that are now private to the base class
why do we have this weekly line here
let's take out this
and try to build really make sure that
this problem is not existent
and it was a visual studio code messing
with us so we're going to bring this in
and the world and we're going to see the
kind of compiler error we get here
this is what i am trying to make you see
you see the bullet is finished with
errors if we go back we're going to see
that string person m address is private
within this context we can't really
resurrect it if we do this we're going
to get this compiler error here this is
the message you shouldn't really try to
resurrect
something that is already private to an
upstream class and that's what we are
doing here we are trying to resurrect a
member which is private to person and
this is not allowed in c plus plus if we
do that we're going to get a compiler
error
okay so but what i want you to see here
is that a public member which was in the
base class was also eclipsed down to
private level access in engineer so if
we try and resurrect
the do something method in our civil
engineer class we're going to get a
compiler error so let's try and do that
we're going to put a public section why
not
and we're going to go down and say using
person
and it say do something we have this
method here but if we do this we're
going to get a compiler error because
this method is now private to the
engineer class and why is it private to
engineer well engineer is doing private
inheritance that's going to accept
everything to private level access by
default so this member is private to
engineer we are inheriting from engineer
in civil engineer
and this is going to be already private
to engineer and we can't resurrect this
back so if you eclipse something using
private inheritance you want to be able
to resurrect that to a more relaxed
access level in downstream classes this
is the message i am trying to convey
here so this is also going to give us a
compiler error
and if we try to build our program we're
going to see that let's pass this
through gcc we are going to see that's
the world finished with errors and if we
go back we are going to get some kind of
error that says that do something is
private to some class it is inaccessible
within this context this is the message
we get from this particular compiler we
are using but the bottom line is that
you shouldn't really try to resurrect
something that is already private to an
upstream class and this is what we are
doing here you shouldn't really do that
let's comment this out and get a code to
compile again
so the web is good and we are all fine
here this is really all i had to share
in this lecture i hope you found it
interesting we are going to stop here in
this one the next one we're going to
explore how constructors work with
inheritance
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this lecture we're going to zoom in
at how derived objects are built and
we're going to zoom in on the
constructors that we have been ignoring
on purpose so far so here we have the
inheritance hierarchy we will be using
it is what we are familiar with at this
point we have a personal class which is
going to be our base class we have an
engineer class which is now going to be
doing public inheritance because we have
seen enough of private inheritance our
engineer class is now going to be nice
and say
i am inheriting from person but i also
want my downstream classes to have
access to the cool stuff i am getting
from person this is how
our engineer class is behaving now we
are also going to have a civil engineer
class which is going to publicly inherit
from engineer but what we want to focus
on here is what we get from base classes
so the engineer class is going to have a
person part of that but it is also going
to build on top of that and add an
engineer level and customize what kind
of person it is so if we inherit from
engineer and that weld our civil
engineer class the first link to be
built by c plus plus is the person part
of this it is going to build an engineer
level of this and then we are going to
add a civil engineer level
to add the customizations that the civil
engineer class is adding
and a c plus plus is going to do this
using constructors by default we are
going to be using default constructors
if we don't specify a way for the
basical structure to be called c plus
plus is going to call the default
constructor to build your base objects
so if we set up something like this and
try to run a program we're going to get
output like this we're going to see that
the person default constructor is going
to be called first and notice that we
are building a civil engineer object so
the default constructor from the most
base class is going to be called then
we're going to be building an engineer
layer on top of the person stuff that we
get then we're going to build a civil
engineer layer on top of the engineer
stuff that we have already got and the
compiler is going to do this using the
default constructors by default so we're
going to call the default constructor
for person first we're going to call the
default constructor for engineer and
then we're going to call the default
constructor for civil engineer to
complete the construction of our object
the object will be complete at this
point and we will be able to use it
later on in our program here and
hopefully this is going to drive the
point home
that you should really really always
provide to the photoconstructors for
your classes because the compiler may
call these default constructors in
unexpected ways especially if your class
is part of an inheritance hierarchy for
example if somebody tries to build the
civil engineer object and you don't have
a default constructor for a person the
compiler is going to try and code that
and it's not going to find that and it
is going to throw a compiler error as we
are about to see in a minute okay so the
message really in this lecture is that
the most base part of your class is
going to be bolt so for example for our
civil engineer class we're going to
build the prison port first then we're
going to build the engineer park and
then we're going to build the civil
engineer part of that and then we're
going to finish the construction of our
object this is the message here now that
you notice we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with this a
little more
here we are in our working folder the
current project is default argument
constructor with inheritance we are
going to reuse the code from the last
lecture because that's going to give us
the classes that we need to play
with what we want to do in this lecture
and that's playing with default
constructors let's put in our starter
code and we're going to open this little
guy in visual studio code let's do this
so we're going to have our classes we're
going to have the main function which we
can play with
and we are going to look at the person
class and make sure we have a default
constructor we are not going to default
it this time because we want to have a
body we can put our output statements in
so in this case we're going to go in the
cpp file and put in a default
constructor we're going to say person
and person and person here and this is
going to be our constructor we're going
to say stdcl defaults constructor for
person called
okay so the personal class is done we
have a default constructor that works as
we want and we're going to go to our
engineer class and we're going to change
it to do public inheritance i think this
is going to be much easier to deal with
now
and we're going to remove all these
resurrection we were doing here from the
last lecture because this is no longer
going to be needed
and what we really want is to look at
our default constructor which is really
in here already let's look at the
implementation all we really need to do
is put in sddc out and say default
constructor
for
engineer
called
and we're going to hop over to the civil
engineer class and see if we have a
default constructor and we do have it
and we're going to go to the cpp file
and say sddcl
default constructor called
for civil engineer
so this is going to basically do what we
want and what we really want to see
is how or the order in which our
constructors are going to be called if
we build a civil engineer object as we
have seen here the person part is going
to be built first so this is going to
call the constructor from person and
because we are not doing any kind of
customization on which constructor is
going to be called the compiler is going
to call the default constructor by
default so we're going to build the
person port first and we're going to see
the default constructor for a person
called after that we're going to build
the engineer part of us
and this is going to call the default
constructor for engineer and after that
we're going to weld the civil engineer
part of us and that's going to call the
civil engineer default constructor this
is what we want to see
if we build a civil engineer object so
we are going to hop over in the main cpp
file and actually build the civil
engineer object we're going to say civil
engineer and we're going to say ce1 we
can do that and we're going to see what
happens let's try and build this program
we're going to build that with gcc the
book is going to be good we could run it
let's bring up a powershell window we
can play with
we want to bring up a powershell window
we can clear
and run rooster
and you're going to see that default
constructor for a person called the
first constructor for engineer called
default constructor for
engineer called this is what we want to
see and hopefully this proves that the
compiler is really going to build a
civil engineer object in parts the
compiler is going to see that it is a
derived object and it's going to see all
the classes that this is deriving from
so it is going to build the most base
part first after that it is going to
build other layers until it reaches the
level where we are at at this civil
engineer objects again if we put another
statement out here i'm going to say
hello in here
and we're going to say sdd-endl
and i am doing this so that i just have
a point where i can put my breakpoint
some ides are not going to like it if
you put a breakpoint at an empty line so
that's why i am doing it here and i am
going to try and debug and really show
you that we have an engineer and a
person part in us i have shown you this
before but it doesn't really hurt to
repeat this
because debugging is really cool it's
going to give you more information than
you could ever ask for
we're going to hit our break point here
and if we look in our
locals we're going to have our civil
engineer object which is in scope now
and you see that we have an engineer
part of us and the engineer has a person
partner so what the compiler is really
going to do when it is building a civil
engineer object it is going to build the
most based part of us so it is going to
build a personal part after that it is
going to build an engineer layer on top
of that and then it is going to world
the servo engineer layer and that's what
we see in our output when we get to run
our program here if we go back we're
going to see that we still have our
binary we can still run it
let's bring up a terminal window we can
use to run this we're going to run
rooster and we're going to see the order
in which our constructors are called
this is really cool now that we have
just debugged this program you can take
out this hello line because it's really
useless and this is really what i wanted
you to see constructors are going to be
called in your inheritance hierarchy
starting from the most basic
going down to the most specialized one
so we're going to call the most best
constructor which is person and we're
going to keep going until we reach the
most specialized which is a civil
engineer here to build our object and
our object is really going to be build
up in layers this is the message i am
trying to convey here this is really all
i had to share in this lecture i hope
you found it interesting we are going to
stop here in this one the next one we're
going to see that we can actually
actively call a base class constructor
from our derived class and that's going
to add much more flexibility in how our
objects are built we are not going to
call the default constructor we're going
to be calling our own constructors and
have much more control on how our
derived objects are set up in the world
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
in the next lecture
in this lecture we're going to see a way
we can instruct for custom constructors
to be called
when our derived objects are being built
and set up
in the last lecture we saw a figure like
this we had an inheritance hierarchy
that went from person to engineer and to
civil engineer and we saw that if we set
up a civil engineer object a personal
part is going to be built first an
engineer part is going to be built on
top of that and the civil engineer part
of that is going to be
built and then we're going to have the
construction complete for our civil
engineer object but in the last lecture
we saw that this was calling the default
constructors and sometimes you don't
want this you want your objects built in
a specific way for example through a
bunch of parameters that you pass to
your constructor what if you want this
kind of setup this is what we are going
to learn about in this lecture and what
we want to end up with is something like
this we will be able to build a person
object by passing in a bunch of
parameters we can pass in
the full name we can pass in the age i
think this is the age we can pass in an
address we can build an engineer object
by passing in this kind of information
we can pass in the name the age and the
address but we can also pass in the
contract count i think this is the new
member variable we had in our engineer
class but we're not going to stop there
we can also build the civil engineer
object and we can pass in the
information again a civil engineer is
also a person so we're going to be
passing the information that is going to
initialize the person part and that
happens to be the name the age and the
address but a civil engineer is also an
engineer so we're going to pass
information that portrays to the level
of an engineer and that's going to be
the contract count and we're going to
pass the information to initialize the
civil engineer part of this object and
that's going to be the road strength
and hopefully from this you can see that
we need a way
to forward all this information to the
constructor where this information is
needed for example if we are building a
civil engineer object we want to forward
the name the age and the address to the
person part of us so we need to parse
this to our personal constructor in a
way we need to pass the 31 here to our
engineer constructor because this
information is going to be stored at our
engineer level and we need to store the
road strength information into the civil
engineer part of us because that's where
this member variable is declared
hopefully you can see the need to call
custom constructors which are not to
default these custom constructors are
going to allow us to forward information
when building our objects like we are
doing here in the main function so let's
see how we can do this some of you might
think uh-huh if i am building an
engineer object i can just grab the
information and pass that to my base
class and that is simple right so we can
grab all this information we can grab
the full name the age and the address
and pass that to our base class using
the syntaxes we have here if we are
doing public inheritance we're going to
have access to these guys anyway so we
can say full name equals full name mag
equals age and say m address equals
address
except
for the address is actually private to
the person class and we can't do
something like this if we try to access
the address member variable from the
base class and modify it we're going to
get a compiler error that says that the
address is actually private to the base
person class we can't do this so this is
not going to work okay some of you might
think uh-huh what if i try to use an
initializer list and do something like
this so i can say m full name and pass
in my information i can say mh and put
in my information i can say m address
and put in my information and then
initialize
the member variable that actually
belongs to the engineer class that we
are trying to build an object for here
and hopefully this is going to work
except the compiler is not also going to
accept this the reason is with
initializer lists you can't initialize a
member variable that doesn't belong to
the class that you are trying to build
an object for so for example here we are
trying to initialize m full name mh and
m address but these member variables
don't belong to the engineer class that
we are trying to build an object for so
we're going to get a compiler error here
this is not going to work it is not
engineer's job
to build or set up this member variables
so this is not going to work okay so
how are we supposed to forward
information from derived classes to base
classes
not to worry here we can still use
initializer lists but we are going to
use constructors whose job is going to
be to initialize these member variables
so if we are building an engineer object
and we have information that really
belongs to the person part of us we're
going to call the person constructor to
actually use this information to build
the personal part of us and we're going
to be calling the person constructor in
our initializer list here and after we
do that we're going to initialize a
member variable that actually belongs to
us in our initializer list this is going
to forward information from derived
classes in this case the engineer is the
derived class and the information is
going to be forwarded to the person
constructor which is our base class this
is how this is going to work
okay now that you know this we're going
to head over to visual studio code and
play with us a little more
here we are in our working folder the
current project is constructors with
inheritance we are going to grab the
code from the last lecture because
that's going to be our starting point
and we're going to
paste this
in our current project
we are going to open this little guy in
visual studio code by dragging and
dropping here and this is going to give
us our starter code we're going to have
a person class an engineer class and a
civil engineer class and this is
basically going to set up the hierarchy
we have here and what we want to achieve
is to be able to call our own custom
constructors
when we build our object in layers
information is going to be coming from a
civil engineer object
and we are going to initialize the
person part of us with relevant
information
we're going to initialize the engineer
part of us with relevant information and
we're going to initialize the civil
engineer part of us with relevant
information this is what we want to
achieve okay for that to work we need to
not call default constructors we want to
call actual constructors that are going
to grab the information and forward that
in our member variables for example in
person we have a constructor which is
going to take three pieces of
information
and it is going to pass this information
into our member variables we need to
apply a few changes here for example our
third parameter is passed as a cost
strength member type we are going to
change this to be std strength view
because this is going to save us
on copies
let's say string view here this is going
to work
and this is going to forward information
in a way we want we're going to change
our third parameter to bhtd string view
let's say string view here we're going
to say std string view this is what we
have in our header we're going to be
having the same signature for our
function here
and what is wrong
we have m full name mh and we have m
address here let's try to build and see
if the error goes away sometimes visual
studio code is playing games on us
if we get a compiler error we're going
to try and fix that you see that it is
visual studio code playing with us the
code is just fine here
so
we have our constructor for person it is
going to forward information using our
initializer list here we're going to
look at our
engineer class if we go there we're
going to see that we don't have any
constructor which is going to grab
information in any meaningful way and
put that in our class
so we are going to put in a constructor
that looks like the one we have in our
person class so we can just grab this i
like copy and pasting because that's
going to save me
a few seconds so i am going to put my
constructor here only it is not going to
be called the person it is going to be
engineer and i am going to add a
construct count
member and this is going to be an
integer here to keep things simpler
and we are going to put an
implementation of this constructor in
our engineer class we can go down here
and put that in front of other
constructors let's look at the order we
have in our
header because i like to be consistent
the default constructor is first so
this constructor is going to be second
and we're going to say that it belongs
to the engineer class
using a scope resolution operator here
and we are going to put in our
initializer list
now what we want to do is to call
the constructor for person to initialize
a person part of us and then we're going
to grab the information from the
contract count and we're going to
forward that in our own member variable
the way we're going to achieve this
we're going to call the person
constructor and we're going to pass in
the full name we're going to pass the
age and we're going to pass the address
and then we're going to initialize our
own member variable which is contract
count i think
let's go to the header and look at that
we're going to see that our member
variable is contract count so we're
going to say contract count and we're
going to say contract count param we're
going to name this differently because
we don't want issues with naming here so
let's name our parameter here param
this is going to not confuse the
compiler and once we have this end we
can just put in the body which is going
to be empty because all the
initialization is now done in our
initializer list here
so if we do this we're going to see that
the compiler is going to be happy with
our thing here we're going to go down in
our
civil engineer class
and we're going to grab the constructor
we have an engineer because we're going
to be using this as a starting point
we're going to copy it and go in our
civil engineer class we're going to see
that we don't have a customer
constructor we're going to put this and
we're going to name this civil
engineer and we're going to add a
speciality member
that we want to initialize so we're
going to say
std string view because we want to
forward string data we're going to say
std string view here and we're going to
say speciality and we are going to put
the implementation of this
in our cpp file for a civil engineer
we're going to put this below our
default constructor
let's grab this i lost the desk somehow
so we're going to copy
and we're going to paste down here
we're going to say that this constructor
belongs to the civil engineer class i'm
going to use our scope resolution
operator and after this we're going to
put our initializer list in civil
engineer we will call our engineer
constructor
and it is going to be taking four thanks
we're going to pass in the full name
we're going to pass in the age we're
going to pass in the address and we're
going to pass in the contract account
which we will get from our constructor
from civil engineer but we will also
initialize our specialty member
variables so we're going to say m
speciality and we're going to pass the
spatiality information here
and this is going to initialize our then
we're going to put in an empty body and
our information is going to be properly
forwarded to our base classes so if we
build the civil engineer object proper
information is going to be forwarded to
the engineer part of us
and the proper information is going to
be forwarded to the person part of us
now that we have this in place we can
put in our htdc out statements to let us
know
which constructor was actually called to
build authen we're going to say that it
was our custom constructor that was
called let's say that here we're going
to say
customer constructor called for civil
engineer we are going to go to our
engineer class and also say the same
thing let's go to this cpp file for that
and we're going to put in our htdc out
statement and we're going to say custom
constructor we can copy this to be
consistent with what we had in our
constructor default constructor i should
say and we're going to say custom
constructor called for our engineer
class we're going to go back to person
and we're going to go to the
implementation file and we're going to
copy the message from our default
constructor and we're going to put this
in and say that the custom constructor
was called for person here so now that
we have these guys in we can go to our
main cpp file and include the classes
they are included here we can try to
create a person object just like we saw
in the slides and we're going to try and
build this program and see which
constructor is called to set up this
person object
this shouldn't be rocket science by now
we know that our custom constructor is
going to be called because we are
passing three parameters which should be
forwarded to our member variables
through this initializer last so let's
build with gcc and make sure this is
what we expect we're going to use our
compiler here
the bolt is going to be good as you see
here and if we bring up our powershell
window and run rooster we're going to
see that our custom constructor is
called let's bring up the main cpp file
so that we can see our thing we are
passing this information here and we are
printing our person object and we're
going to see that the full name is jon
snow the age is 27 and the address is
winterfell called and all this gibberish
we have here our constructor is really
being called okay so this is working we
can also set up an engineer object and
see that the information is being
properly propagated to the person part
of our engineer object because engineer
is inheriting from person
we are passing the information for the
full name the age the address but we are
also passing in the contract count which
should be used to initialize the
engineer part of us so we are going to
run the task to build with gcc
the build is going to go through
successfully and we can bring up our
powershell window and run the program
again
we're going to see that we're going to
branch the information for person custom
constructor for person called but what
we really are interested in here
is seeing that the custom constructor
for person is called
for building our engineer object and
then we call the engineer constructor
and again this falls in line with what
we saw in the last lecture the most
based constructor is called first and
then the must specialize constructor is
called last in this case we are just
setting up thanks in such a way that our
custom constructors are called and we do
that from our engineer class by calling
the base constructor explicitly
using the syntax that we have here in
our initializer list after we have the
base constructor called we are going to
initialize our own member variables and
that's what we see
and in this way the information for the
current class will be initialized
properly and this is what we see here i
think this is a little bit misleading
because we still have the information
from
the person objects that we bought
printed out here we can comment this out
and build again we're going to pass this
through gcc to build our program the
build is going to be good we can
clear and run rooster and we're going to
see that the custom constructor is
called for a person to set up the person
part of us and then another layer of
engineer is going to be set up in our
object to initialize the contract count
member variable part of us and we're
going to have the information here so if
we print the full name we're going to
get daniel gray the age is going to be
41. the address is going to be the
gibberish we expect here and the
contract count is going to be passed in
successfully and this is really cool we
can also comment this out and set up a
civil engineer object we can do that
okay so let's go down and put this in
place we're going to create a civil
engineer object we can close up
the left side bar here to have some more
breathing room we're going to build a
civil engineer object we're going to
pass in full name age address contract
count and a speciality which i think we
expect from our civil engineer custom
constructor here
that's going to be an std strength
that's what we are passing in here i
should say that's going to be
a string view but we can pass in string
data just like this and the string view
is going to take
so what we're going to see here we're
going to see the person constructor
called the person custom constructor i
should say we're going to see the
engineer custom constructor called and
after that we're going to see
the civil engineer custom constructor
called to pass and forward all this
information
in related parts of our civil engineer
object let's build and see that this is
actually going to even compile
the book is going to be good we can
clear
and run rooster and we're going to see
that this is exactly what we expect the
custom constructor for person is going
to be called after that
the custom constructor for engineer is
going to be called and then the custom
constructor for a civil engineer is
going to be called
and this really falls in line with what
we expect if we are building a civil
engineer object and the civil engineer
class happens to be inheriting both from
engineer and from person we're going to
have the person part of us world first
and because of this we're going to see
the person constructor called but in
this lecture the rio focus is getting
our custom constructor called so the
person custom constructor is going to be
called after that we're going to call
the custom constructor for the engineer
part of us and that's going to set up
the engineer specific member variables
in our object after that we're going to
set up another layer of civil engineer
in our object and this is going to
initialize the member variable that
belongs to the civil engineer
part of us in our object so this is
really the main goal in this lecture
showing you that you can set up fans in
such a way that your custom constructors
are called when setting up your object
in layers
as you see here okay now that we have
this working i want you to see that
there are some bad ways to do these
things and some people are actually
going to try to set things up in that
way the first bad way is to try and
initialize our member variables in the
body of the class if you do things like
this again this is going to work because
full name and age are going to be
inherited publicly from the person class
so the code here is going to work but we
have no way to initialize the address
member variable because it is private to
the person class so if we try to access
that we're going to get a compiler error
let's try this out in code and see the
actual compiler error to try this out i
am going to comment out the good code
here and i am going to copy and put in
something that is going to be
problematic as we saw in the slides i am
going to paste in my constructor here i
should close my powershell window here
and i am going to take out my
initializer lust because we're not going
to be using that here
and we're going to just grab the data
and use that to initialize our data in
our member variable here so we're going
to grab the full name and say m full
name equals full name we can do that
we're going to say mh equals h that's
the information we get we're going to
say m address and you see that we don't
even have that in autocomplete so we're
going to pass the address we're going to
be stubborn and ignore these squiggly
lines and we're going to say m
speciality and we're going to grab the
speciality and pass that in but you see
that line 26 has a bunch of squiggly
lines
and the reason is the m address member
variable is invisible and not
manipulable from a civil engineer class
again the reason is that the address
member variable is private to the person
class so the civil engineer class has no
business initializing this in the body
this is not going to work so if we try
and build this we're going to pass this
through gcc we are going to see that the
world is going to finish with errors and
if we go up we're going to probably see
the error person m address is private
within this context and we have no
business accessing that in the civil
engineer cpp file at line 26 this is
what we see here and this is the
offending line we shouldn't really be
doing this if we comment out this line
this is going to work but our member
variable is going to be left
with a junk value and this is really not
good because our address that we worked
so hard
to set up in our parameter here is just
going to be ignored so this is bad you
shouldn't really be initializing your
member variables like this especially if
you have an inheritance hierarchy in
your classes so we're going to comment
this out and say that this is really bad
it's going to give you compiler errors
and some of you are going to say okay
this is not working but what if we try
to use an initializer list directly
let's see if that actually works
we are going to
set up another constructor here and we
are going to set up the data in our
initializer list we're going to say
let's say m full
name and pass in the full name we can do
that let's try this out we're going to
say mh
and we're going to pass age we can do
that and we're going to grab the address
and we're going to pass an address here
and after that we're going to say m
spatiality and we're going to pass in
our spatiality information
what if we do something like this but
you're going to see that we have
squiggly lines here and the problem with
this way of doing things is that the
civil engineer class has no business
initializing thanks
that belong to the person class in the
initializer list your initializer list
only has the capability to initialize
the member variables that belong to the
current class and m full name mh and m
address don't belong to the cipher
engineer class that's why we're going to
have a compiler error if we try to set
up things in this way if we're trying to
build the program we're going to get a
weird compiler error
we're going to see that the build is
going to finish with errors and it is
going to say expected initializer before
m full name
and we need a column column here sorry
for this so this is not the error we
expect but you see that the moment we do
this we have a bunch of squiggly lines
on full name age and address and let's
build and see the problem we have and
we're going to build with errors as we
see here if we go up
we are going to see our errors civil
engineer does not have any field called
m full name we're going to see that
civil engineer doesn't have any field
called mh and civil engineer doesn't
have any field named m full name or m
address here that's the problem we have
no business initializing these member
variables that don't belong to the civil
engineer class in the first place so
this is also not going to work the best
bet we have already is to call the best
constructor and let that initialize the
member variables that belong to our
upstream class
in the inheritance hierarchy for example
in our civil engineer constructor here
we need to call the engineer
constructor to initialize the engineer
part of us and we're going to be
forwarding the information the full name
the age the address and the contract
account the engineer class is in turn
going to call its base constructor to
forward the information about the full
name of the agent the address and it is
going to initialize its own member
variable m construct count and the
information is going to be passed in
correctly and if we try to build our
class now we're going to see that
everything is going to work and i really
wanted you to be aware of this because
the moment you understand this you're
going to set up your inheritance
hierarchies in a way that is going to
make sense and you're not going to be
getting all these weird compiler errors
this is really all we set out to do in
this lecture showing you how you can set
up your own custom constructors in your
own inheritance hierarchy and at the
moment you do that you're going to get
your classes called in the order that
you expect things are going to be set up
in layers the base constructors are
going to be called in a way that you
expect and your objects are going to be
built in a way that you can print them
and see the information that you expect
set up in your object if you want you
can also use a debugger to see the
information in your thumb so we're going
to set up a breakpoint here and we're
going to bring up our
debugging tab we're going to hit the
green button to start debugging this
program the binary is going to be set up
once the vote is good the binary is
going to be passed in our debugger and
we are going to hit our breakpoint in a
minute let's wait for this so we have
hit the break point at line 20 and if we
expand our civil engineer object in our
locals we're going to see that we have
an engineer part of us we can expand
that and see that we also have a person
part of us
if we look at person we're going to see
that the full name is we can see john
travolta which is what we are passing
here we can also look at our age the age
is 51 as you see here
and we're going to also have information
about our address
if we expand this we're going to see
that the address is this gibb brush that
we just put in tiny dog
42 stret and
number 89 we can see this information
here and you can really expand and see
all these things that make up our object
for example we can see the information
about the contract count which is 31 and
it is what we are passing when we build
this object here and the speciality
happens to be road strength as we see in
our locals here you can really see all
these things we are going to stop here
in this lecture in the next one we're
going to explore how copy constructors
work in our inheritance hierarchy so go
ahead and finish up here
and meet me there
in this lecture we want to explore how
copy constructors work
with our inheritance hierarchies and we
will still be using the same example we
have been using in this chapter we will
have this inheritance hierarchy and we
will still be using the same example we
have been using in this chapter the base
class is going to be person we're going
to be inheriting from that publicly to
create an engineer class and we will be
inheriting from the engineer class
publicly to create the civil engineer
class and with this we want to be able
to copy construct objects and the code
we want to be running is something like
this we have an engineer object we want
to be able to create another object from
this engineer object using the syntax
here and from what we already know this
is going to call our copy constructor
the funny thing is this is going to work
by default even if you don't put in your
copy constructor the reason is the
compiler is going to insert a copy
constructor for you and things are going
to be copied in a way that you expect
because none of our classes is using
dynamic memory allocation so everything
is just going to fall in place and it is
going to work but if you happen to need
to set up your own copy constructor
we're going to see how you could do that
in this lecture and we're going to start
by the base class we're going to set up
a copy constructor for the person class
and this is nothing complicated we just
pass our parameter by reference this is
going to be our source object and we
will be copying the data from our source
object to initialize the member
variables in the current object that we
are copying here again this is a copy
constructor which will be copy
constructing from the parameter that we
pass by reference now how do we do the
constructor for the engineer class which
happens to be inheriting from person try
to think about that one way to do things
is to set up things like this and this
will be just initializing the engineer
layer of our class but nothing is going
to be initializing the person part of us
and this is bad this is going to call
the default constructor to initialize
the person part of us and we will just
be left in with junk data that is
initializing the person object by
default and all the data we have in our
parameter engineer object is just going
to be lost for the person part of us so
we don't want to do this this is bad
design you shouldn't do this some of you
are going to say but what if we call the
best constructor we have seen that we
could do that right but remember this is
a copy constructor what we have on the
left is an object
and it happens to be that
if you set up a syntax like this with
the copy constructor the compiler is
going to set up a temporary person
object and a copy from that object to
initialize the person part of us so this
is going to be creating a temporary copy
object containing the same data we have
in our engineer object so to some extent
this is going to work but the problem we
still have is that we are using the m
address member variable directly from an
engineer object and from what we already
know this m address member variable is
private to the person class and we have
no business accessing this
from an engineer construct so this is
going to give us a compiler error but
you know that it is possible to set up a
getter in the engineer class that is
going to return this address and you can
call that together here and get this
thing to initialize your data this is
going to work but this is really weird
you shouldn't do this this is bad design
there is a better way i am going to show
you but before we look at that wave
let's try and summarize the problems we
have with this way of doing things this
is not going to be reusing the copy
constructor we have worked hard to set
up in person so this is just going to be
called duplication another thing is that
the m address member variable is private
to person so if we try and use it like
this we're going to get a compiler error
again it is possible to set up a getter
that could return that and we could use
that getter in this place but this is
bad design we are really forced to set
up a getter that is possibly only used
in this place that's bad design we don't
want to do something like this another
thing is that this is going to create a
temporary copy of person from which we
will be copying to initialize the person
part of us we don't want to be making
that copy because we hate copies in c
plus plus code so the best way to do
this is to set up your copy constructor
in this way we are going to say person
and directly passing our engineer object
the compiler is smart enough to see that
we are passing an engineer object to
initialize a person object and what the
compiler is going to do is really smart
suppose our engineer object is made up
of two layers the inner layer is going
to be containing the information about
the person part of us and the outer
layer is going to be containing the
engineer part of us okay so this is the
setup we have so the compiler is going
to see that we are passing in an
engineer object to initialize a person
object and what it is going to do is
really smart it is going to strip off
all this engineer part if i can describe
it like this we're going to strip off
all this engineer part
that we have in our engineer object and
we will be just left with the person
part that we passed then to initialize
our person object and this is really
smart and it is going to work so again
the syntax is what you see here
we say person we pass in our source
object and then we can initialize the
member variable that belong to the
engineer part of us we will be
initializing contract count and this is
going to work now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is copy constructors
with inheritance we will be reusing the
code from the last lecture so we're
going to grab everything from that
except for the binary and we're going to
copy that and put that in our current
project let's do this and we are going
to open this bad boy in visual studio
code by dragging and dropping here and
we will have our starting point we will
have our person class the engineer class
and the civil engineer class and we will
just be doing public inheritance to make
things easier here so engineer is going
to publicly inherit from person and
civil engineer is going to publicly
inherit from engineer and this is
everything we had from the last lecture
nothing special but what we want is to
set up copy constructors in such a way
that we will be able to build objects
from others for example if we leave in
our engineer object i think this is what
we used in the slides we're going to
have our engineer 1 object
we want to be able to create a another
engineer let's say engineer two and
above that from engineer one the thing
that might be puzzling to some of you is
that this is going to work out of the
box even if we didn't really put in a
copy constructor but the thing is the
compiler is going to insert a copy
constructor for you but that constructor
is going to be memberwise
copy so it is basically going to be
copying thanks memberwise it is going to
take the contract count from engineer
one and copy that into engineer two and
we are basically going to have the same
data from
engineer one in engineer two let's try
and print engineer two can do that we're
going to say and two and we're going to
put this out and we are going to run the
task to build with gcc that's what we
want here and you're going to see that
it is going to work out of the box if we
bring up a powershell window and run
rooster we're going to see that we have
the data in here we have engineer full
name daniel gray that's the data we have
in engineer one but notice that we are
printing engineer two here the age is
going to be 41 and the address is going
to be exactly what we had in engineer
one and you're going to see that the
constructors are going to be called to
set up engineer 2 and the custom
constructor for a person is going to be
called the custom constructor for
engineer is going to be called and this
is exactly
what we expect here but what if we want
to set up our own copy constructor and
the need to do that might arise
if we happen to be doing some dynamic
memory allocation in our classes suppose
maybe person class has some dynamic
memory allocation it has some pointer
member variable and in the personal
custom constructor we are doing some
dynamic memory allocation to initialize
that pointer we may be doing the same
thing at the engineer level or the civil
engineer level and that will force you
to set up your own copy constructor and
we're going to see how you could do that
in your classes we are going to start
with the person class we're going to go
on top and set up a copy constructor in
front of our destructor here we're going
to say person and we're going to say
const person reference source
this is the syntax you use to set up
your copy constructor you already know
this from a previous chapter and we're
going to put in the implementation for
this we're going to go in the cpp file
before the destructor or we should go
after
our custom constructor it doesn't really
matter where you put this and we're
going to put in our scope resolution
operator let's do person here and we
will just be copying the data from the
source person so we're going to put in
our initializer list and we're going to
say m full name we're going to grab the
name from the source person we're going
to say source m full name we're going to
initialize the age we're going to say mh
and we're going to grab the age from the
source person so mh here
and we can go to the next line so that
we see the entire thing here and say m
address and we're going to say source
and say m address this is going to set
up our constructor and down below we can
put in our body this is going to work
but this is everything we have seen so
far this is nothing new the syntax to
set up your copy constructor you just
pass it by const reference if you don't
pass by reference here you're going to
get an endless chain of copy constructor
calls
if this is confusing to you please go
back to the chapter on classes you're
going to see everything about this and
this is really all we need to do here to
have a copy constructor for a person now
let's do things at the engineer level
we're going to go to our engineer class
and we need to set up a copy constructor
the syntax is going to be the same we're
going to say engineer and we will be
constructing from a cost engineer object
we pass as a parameter here so we're
going to say cost engineer by reference
and say source and the problem is going
to be how we implement this thing we're
going to copy this and go in our
engineer cpp file we're going to put our
copy constructor after our customer
constructor and we're going to put in
our scope resolution operator we're
going to say engineer and we're going to
put in our body let's go below and put
that in if we do things like this this
is just going to initialize our engineer
with junk data we don't want that but
some of you might say uh-huh i don't
know how to call my base constructor but
at least i can initialize my contract
count okay let's go back and see if we
have this member variable here yes it is
called contract count we can say
contract count here and we are going to
initialize this with source contract
count this is going to work but this is
going to call the default constructor of
person to initialize the person part of
us and let's go back in our main cpp
file and see what we are using to try
things out we are building an engineer
object from another let's try this out
and see if our copy constructor is
called here so we're going to say custom
copy constructor called for engineer
we're going to put in the message and
we're going to say custom copy
constructor and we're going to build our
code let's build we're going to pass
this through gcc to see what happens the
build is going to be good and let's see
what happens we're going to clear and
run rooster we are going to see that the
constructors are going to be called to
set up person one
but we see that the copy constructor for
engineer is called
and what i want to do to really make
this super clear is put a separator
between these two guys to really know
what is happening here i am going to put
in a bunch of dashes just like this i am
going to put in my new line character
and i am going to bolt again the bolt is
going to be good as you see here we can
clear and run rooster now we are going
to see that the default constructor for
person was called to set up the person
part of us in our engineer copy
constructor and the reason is we are not
doing anything to call the custom copy
constructor from person
and let's go back in person and make
sure we are printing proper information
to really see this
when we get to do this right we are not
putting in any message here so we should
do that we are going to say custom
constructor or custom copy constructor
called for person but this is not called
you see that we are calling the default
constructor and this is going to
initialize our person part with junk
data if we print engineer two here
you're going to see that the full name
is none the edge is zero and the address
is none so we are basically getting the
default data we have in our person
object let's go back and really show you
that the
default full name is going to be none
the default address is going to be none
of the edge is going to be 0 by default
and this is what we get because in our
copy constructor we're not doing
anything to get our customer constructor
in person to be called okay so this is
not going to work this is bad we don't
want to do something like this but let's
comment this out and show you another
way we might try to do things and we are
going to copy our copy constructor let's
go down and do this we're going to put
in another copy of this but we don't
want to just initialize our contract
count member variable
instead we want to do something else
we're going to put a comma here and
we're going to say person some of you
might be thinking what if we call the
base constructor directly we can do
something like this we can say person
and we can say source m full name we can
do that we can say source mh and some of
you are going to say source m address
let's do that source m address and we're
going to build the person object and use
that to initialize the person part of us
we are basically going to be calling the
other person constructor that we have
which takes three parameters this
constructor here this is what we are
trying to call
in our copy constructor but as we saw in
the slides this is going to have a bunch
of problems this is going to be creating
a temporary person object that we are
going to be copying from to set up the
person part of us but another problem we
have which is actually going to cause a
compiler error is that we don't have
access to the m address member variable
from an engineer constructor and this is
going to give us a compiler error let's
actually try and compile this program to
really show you this we are learning we
should really see
as many compiler errors as we can so the
world is finished with errors and if we
go up we're going to see that our error
is the m address member variable is
private to the person class and we have
no business accessing that in the
engineer cpp file at line 27 in our
constructor here and this is going to be
our offending line we can't do this one
could go in our person class and set up
a public getter method which is going to
be inherited by engineer and we could
call that to return the address let's
actually do that to show you that you
can do that
so we are going to go in and put in a
public method which is going to return
the address we actually have that here
so we can call that we can say
source get address this is going to work
this is going to set up our thumb
let's try to build because i think a
visual studio code is messing with us
here okay you see the both is good it is
visual studio code which wasn't
understanding our code here and if we
run our program we're going to see that
things are going to work exactly as we
expect let's actually
run the program here we're going to
clear and run rooster we're going to see
that now the information is being
forwarded properly but we are setting up
a temporary person copy which we are
copying from
to then forward the data to the person
part of us this is not good design and
what we really want is the setup that is
going to allow us to call the copy
constructor that we worked hard to set
up in our base class here let's go back
to person and see that if we go up we're
going to see that we have a copy
constructor we really worked hard to set
up we wanted to reuse this in our
engineer class and that's what we're
going to see here so this is working but
it is not optimal
and we should really try to reuse our
code as much as we can so what we're
going to do is set up a mechanism that
is going to reuse the copy constructor
we have in person and all we need to do
to get that to work we can say person
and then call the copy constructor of
person by directly passing in our source
object notice that we don't need to set
up a temporary person object we will
directly be copying from our engineer
object but this is going to do the
slicing we saw in the slides again if we
have two layers on our object the inner
layer is going to be the person part of
us and the outer green layer is going to
be
the engineer part of us
what the compiler is going to do the
compiler is going to see that we are
actually passing again
an
engineer object to initialize the person
part of us here and it is going to say
that we just need the red part we don't
need the green part here the compiler is
really smart so it is going to slice off
the outer engineer layer
and only leaving
the green
person part and it is going to use that
to initialize the person part of our
engineer object and this will be reusing
the copy constructor we have in our
person object then this is really cool
this is the optimal way to set up your
copical structures if you have an
inheritance hierarchy so let's try and
build the code again we're going to pass
this through gcc to see if this actually
works the bullet is going to be good we
can clear and run rooster we're going to
see that the copy constructor is going
to be called for person to set up the
person part of us and then the custom
copy constructor for engineer is going
to be called to set up the engineer part
of us and if we look at the information
we have in the main function you're
going to see that it is the same data
daniel gray for the full name ages 41
address is this gibberish here and the
contract count is 12 it is exactly what
we passed here and our copy constructor
is working now that we have this working
we can safely reuse the same ideas
in our civil engineer copy constructor
we can head over in our civil engineer
and set up the copy constructor so let's
do that we can
close the left sidebar here so that we
see the entire thing we are going to say
civil engineer and we want to set up a
copy constructor so we're going to say
cast civil engineer here and we will be
passing this by reference we're going to
say source and we're going to put the
implementation of this in our cpp file
we can hop over there and go below our
custom constructor we can put in our
constructor here we're going to say
civil engineer and put in our scope
resolution operator and we're going to
go down and put in the body and in our
initializer list we're going to call the
copy constructor from engineer because
remember civil engineer is inheriting
from the engineer class so we are going
to call the engineer copy constructor
we're going to pass in source and again
this is going to slice off the civil
engineer port and only use the engineer
part of us to construct an engineer
object from this sliced of engineer
object we get from our copy constructor
here and this is really cool after that
we will initialize our contract count
member variable oh it is m speciality if
i remember correctly and we're going to
grab a source m speciality and we will
use that to initialize the civil
engineer part of us here let's go in and
say that the custom copy constructor is
being called here and we're going to say
custom copy constructor called for a
civil engineer what did we do here we
said engineer let's do engineer this is
what we want and we're going to say
engineer here properly sorry for this
but this is no big deal and now that we
have this in place we can actually build
civil engineer objects and copy
constructed them we can
comment out the engineering stuff we
have and we can just put this in a black
comment and we're going to copy
construct civil engineers how cool is
that we're going to set up a civil
engineer let's do that
and this is going to be a civil engineer
and we're going to say daniel gray we're
going to put in all the data and we're
going to specify the speciality to be
road strength this is something i just
made up i don't even know
if this kind of speciality exists and we
will set up another civil engineer
object called n2 which we are going to
be copy constructing from and we will
see what happens when we copy construct
this thing here we should call our copy
constructor in civil engineer and the
things should propagate up all the way
to the person part of us and we're going
to see what happens let's build this
code we're going to pass this through
gcc as we always do the budget is going
to be good so this is good news we're
going to clear and run rooster and we're
going to see that the custom copy
constructor is called for person the
custom copy constructor is going to be
called for engineer and the custom copy
constructor is going to be called full
civil engineer and you see that things
are really propagating all the way to
the person part and we are calling and
reusing our copy constructors and this
is really cool if you go down you're
going to see that the information is
printed out correctly the full name is
daniel gray which we have in engineer
one the age is 41 the address is all
this gibberish the contract count is 12
and the speciality is road strength and
we are
properly reusing our copy constructors
in our inheritance hierarchy this is
really all i had to share in this
lecture again the syntax you should be
using to set up your copy constructors
is what we see here this is going to be
reusing the code we have in our upper
classes in our hierarchy we will be
avoiding the temporary copies we saw
when we called the other constructor
directly and this is much cleaner it is
reusing code we have in other classes we
are going to stop here in this lecture
in the next one we're going to see that
it is actually possible to inherit base
constructors go ahead and finish up here
and meet me there in this lecture we're
going to explore the fact that we can
inherit base constructors and use them
in our derived classes we will build
we're using the same hierarchy we have
been using so we will have the person
class and we will be inheriting from
this person to create an engineer class
and that's what we're going to be using
to learn about this concept here so the
personal class is what we know from the
previous lectures we have a bunch of
member variables here we have the full
name the age and the address and we have
a bunch of constructors now we have a
default constructor a custom constructor
and a copy constructor that we set up
tirelessly in the last lecture now what
do we mean when we say that we can
inherit a constructor well based
constructors are not inherited by
default and what we mean by that is that
by default it is really not possible
to get derived classes to use base
constructors to set up things but it is
possible to tell the compiler to use the
base constructor to set up our own
objects for example we can put our
statement here saying
using person column column person this
is going to tell the compiler when
welding engineer objects don't use your
own constructor set up a base like a
constructor which is going to only
initialize the base member variables and
the compiler is going to see this
statement and it is going to generate a
constructor for you that looks something
like this so it is going to be engineer
it is going to be taking in the full
name the age and the address and it is
going to be forwarding the work to
initialize your object to the person
class and this is all this constructor
is going to do hopefully you can see
that this is called inheriting a base
constructor because all this constructor
is really doing is initializing the base
member variables it's not initializing
any member variable that belongs to the
engineer class so the engineer part of
us is going to be basically empty
containing junk data that we get by just
calling the default constructor and we
will only be initializing the data
belonging to the person part of us this
is really what i want you to see again
the syntax is what we see here
this is going to tell the compiler to
generate a constructor that is only
going to initialize the base member
variables but this constructor will be
callable and usable from the engineer
class
okay so this is really what we mean
by inheriting constructors one thing you
should know is that the constructor is
going to be inherited with whatever
access
specifier it had in the base class so if
our constructor was in the public scope
it's going to be inherited with public
access so we will be able to use it from
the outside and world engineer objects
if it was in a protected scope we want
to be able to use it from the outside if
it was private we won't even be able to
use it from a derived class you should
really know that so it is going to be
inherited with whatever access specifier
we had in our base class now that we
know this let's see some things you
should really be careful about the first
is that copy constructors are not
inheritable if you try to do that you're
going to get a compiler error but you
won't usually notice this because the
compiler is going to insert copy
constructors for you anyway this is
going to become a problem if you are
doing some dynamic memory allocation and
you're going to get pointers copied this
is really bad if you don't know about
this please go back to the chapter on
classes and you're going to see all the
story about shallow copying and deep
copying we talked about these things
another thing you should know is that
inherited constructors are really based
constructors and what we mean by this is
that they will only be initializing the
base member variables because they are
based constructors they have no
knowledge of derived member variables
that's why they only initialize base
member variables again as we said the
constructors are inherited with whatever
access specifier they had in the base
class and it is possible to set up your
own constructors on top of the inherited
constructors and you can use these
things another thing i should really
tell you is that inheritance
constructors is going to make your code
really confusing it is a technical
possibility but i strongly advise
against using this in your code because
it is just going to confuse people
people are going to see for example an
engineer constructor and they are going
to think that that constructor is going
to even initializing the engineer member
variables but it's not going to do that
because it is a base constructor it's
only going to be initializing the base
member variables and that may lead to
some confusion or even really bad
problems in your code so don't use this
it is just going to make things
confusing but i wanted you to be aware
of this and if you see this kind of
setup in classes out there you will know
what they mean this is just going to
inherit a base constructor and use it to
build objects now that we know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is inheriting based
constructors we are going to steal code
from the last lecture and we will be
using the main cpp file the person class
and the engineer class this is just
going to be enough for our purposes here
we're going to go back in our current
project and we're going to put this in
and we will open this in visual studio
code by dragging and dropping here this
is going to give us our thumb
and let's go to person and see that we
have our constructors and we have a
default constructor we have a custom
constructor and we have a copy
constructor one thing you should know is
that copy constructors are not inherited
so you will need to set up your copy
constructors explicitly if you want to
use them know that they want to be
coming from the upstream class you
should know that okay so this is the
message here now let's look at our
engineer class the engineer class is
publicly inheriting from person and it
has a bunch of its own constructors but
what we want to do is to take out all
these constructors and we're going to
take them out i think we can uh yeah
we're going to take them out let's do
that and we're going to go in our cpp
file and also take out all these
constructors here we're going to comment
them out i think we can take out all
these bad code we got from previous
lectures and we're going to just comment
out our constructors we're going to
close them all with a blog comment and
what we are going to do in our class is
say
using person person we're going to say
using person person this is going to
inherit the constructors from person and
now that we have this in place the
compiler is really going to generate a
base like constructor in our engineer
class in other words we're going to have
a default engineer constructor which is
just going to not initialize anything we
are going to have a custom constructor
which is going to take three parameters
but it is going to be an engineer
constructor and let's prove this we're
going to go in our main cpp file and
we're going to take out everything we
have here and we don't have a civil
engineer file so we shouldn't really
include that and we are going to create
an engineer object we can say and one
using the default constructor we can try
and print that out and you're going to
see that this code seems to work in
visual studio code we can try and build
this we're going to pass this through
gcc and we are going to
set up a powershell window we can use to
run and see things
and we're going to see that the default
constructor for person was called to
initialize this guy
and the data is really junk data we have
in person so what the compiler is really
doing behind the scenes is to generate a
bezel-like constructor at the engineer
level and it is going to call the base
constructor to initialize the person
part of us so the data is just going to
be junk data we have in person and
you're going to see that the contract
count is going to be zero this is just a
default constructor which is just going
to grab whatever default data we have in
our object you see the contract count is
zero if we go back in person we're going
to see that the full name is none which
is what we see here the age is zero and
the address is none this is a default
constructor but we can even explicitly
pass in the data and that's going to
also work so we can pass in the full
name to be
daniel gray we can pass in the edge to
b23 for example and we can pass in a
junk address let's say something like
this and you see that this is going to
work even if we don't have any engineer
constructor
that takes three parameters let's go
back and you're going to see that all
our constructors are commented out but
this is working because we told the
compiler to generate
a base like constructor for our engineer
so it is going to also have in
an engineer constructor that looks like
this constructor here which takes in
three parameters and this is really cool
and this is really crucial to understand
so again we are going to set up a
constructor for engineer so it is going
to be an engineer constructor but it is
going to be taking three parameters just
like the person constructor here and
this is the message i really want to
convey here so if we run this code
you're going to see that it is going to
work it is going to call our baseline
constructor for engineer and we're going
to have the data forwarded and but
you're going to see that the contract
count is not going to be taken into
account so it is going to still contain
some default data if we try and pass
that in we're going to see that we're
going to get a compiler error because
now we have no such constructor that
takes four parameters the only one we
have is one that is generated because of
this statement here and this is going to
be a baseline constructor which is just
going to take three parameters just like
this constructor here and another thing
i don't think i made clear enough is
that this is going to bring in all the
constructors you have notice that we
just put in this statement but it is
going to grab all these constructors we
have except for the copy constructors
which are not inherited in c plus plus
so you should really know this if we
build this code we're going to get a
compiler error because the compiler
wants to know
what to do with the 45 parameter that we
have here but let's build and really
show you this you need to see this
compiler error with your own eyes let's
go in so the world is finished with
errors and we have an error saying no
matching function called to this
constructor which takes four parameters
if we take this out we're going to see
that this is going to work this is going
to use the compiler generated
constructor
as a result of this statement we have in
our code now if we will we're going to
see that this is going to work okay the
build is good can clear and run rooster
we're going to see that we have the full
name to be daniel gray we have the h2b23
we have our address which is really some
junk data and the contract count has no
data in it is just the default data we
have in our member variable here we have
no way to initialize this from a base
like a constructor but not everything is
really bad news if you don't want to be
limited by the constructors that are
generated by your compiler as a result
of inheritance you can set up your own
constructors for example we can uncover
our engineer constructor here and bring
it out of our comment we can do
something like this we can go in the
implementation file and also bring this
out of our comment section and now we
will be able to use this constructor
which is going to take the fourth
parameter here and do something with
that now if we go back in main the code
with three parameters is going to work
it is going to use the compiler
generated constructor but if we pass the
contract count to b4 this is also going
to work because it is going to be using
our own constructor here if we build the
code we're going to see that it is going
to work just fine let's use gcc to show
this
you're going to see that the world is
good we can clear
and run rooster
now our contract count is taken into
account this is really cool this is
really all i wanted you to see in this
lecture that you can let the compiler
generate the baseline constructor using
the syntax we have in our header here
this using statement can really show up
anywhere but it is going to inherit the
constructor with whatever access
specifier the constructor had in the
base class and you should really keep
these points in mind especially the last
one that
inheriting constructors is going to make
your code confusing people are going to
notice that they can call constructors
that are really not going to be
initializing derived member variables
and this may cause serious problems in
your code we are going to stop here in
this lecture in the next one we're going
to explore how inheritance works with
these structures so far we have been
ignoring the structures we are going to
focus on them in the next lecture so go
ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
focus on how destructors work with
inheritance and suppose we have an
inheritance hierarchy like we have been
using all along in this chapter so our
base class is person we have the
engineer class which is publicly
inheriting from person and we have a
civil engineer class which is inheriting
from engineer publicly so when we create
a civil engineer object we have seen
that the burst part is built first so we
are going to build the personal part of
us we are going to build the engineer
part of us on top of that and we are
going to build the civil engineer part
of us on top of that so the constructors
are going to be called in this order we
will call the person constructor first
engineer constructor after that and then
a civil engineer constructor after that
to set up our civil engineer object the
thing i want you to see in this lecture
is that the structures are called in the
reverse order to that so the most
specialized destructor is going to be
called first then we're going to destroy
the engineer part of us and the person
part of us is going to be destroyed last
so we are going to construct things in
this order from the base part to the
most specialized one and then we are
going to destroy thanks in this order so
these structures are going to be called
in the reverse order than the
constructors that's the message i want
to convey here and we're going to set up
a simple example to play with us we're
going to create a civil engineer object
and we're going to see the order in
which these things are called and let's
head over to visual studio code and
actually do this here we are in our
working folder the current project is
inheritance and destructors we are going
to be reusing the code from a previous
lecture i don't think the last lecture
is a good example because we don't have
a civil engineer class so we are going
to go to the lecture before that and use
the code from our lecture or the copy
constructors with inheritance that's
going to give us all the classes we have
person engineer and civil engineer and
we need that in this lecture here so
let's grab all these things we're going
to copy them and put them in our current
object
which is inheritance and the structures
and we are going to open this in visual
studio code and it is going to be our
starting point here so we have person
engineer and civil engineer let's see
what we are doing and the main cpp file
we can take out all the junk here or we
can leave in the civil engineer object
we are creating here and we're going to
see how
the constructors and the instructors are
called we're going to go to person and
make sure we have a constructor and we
have a bunch of constructors and
let's go to the cpp file and see that we
have messages in our constructors this
is really
what we expect but we want to also put a
message in the destructor let's say sddc
out and say destructor for person called
this is going to do we're going to go in
our engineer class we're going to see
that we have a bunch of constructors we
have a destructor here we're going to
hop over in the cpp file
and make sure we take out the bad code
here because we don't really need that
we only need good code and we make sure
that we have output statements in our
constructors to know when they are
called looks like we are good we're
going to put an sddc out statement in
our destructor for engineer or engineer
called this is going to do and we are
going to hop over in our civil engineer
class we're going to have a bunch of
constructors we're going to have a civil
engineer
destructor
we can go in the cpp file and make sure
that we have output statements in our
civil engineer constructors looks like
we are good here we can take out all the
bad code we don't need and we are going
to put a message in our destructor here
so let's do that the the structure
called for civil engineer i think this
is going to be good enough let's go back
and make sure we have the same messages
here for engineer
and we have a destructor for person
called message and we're going to try
and run the code and see how
constructors and destructors are called
this is the order we want to make sure
we understand if you want you can even
use a debugger to follow things but i am
not going to do that here i am just
going to weld and show you the output
statements
hopefully that's going to be proof
enough
that things happen in the order that i
just described in the slides the build
is good we can clear we can bring up a
powershell window and then clear and
we're going to run rooster we're going
to see that the constructor is going to
be called for person for civil engineer
and you're going to see that things are
going to happen from the must-based
constructor to the most specialized
constructor so we are going to call
person engineer and civil engineer but
you're going to see that the structures
are going to be called in the reverse
order
the most specialized the destructor is
going to be called the first then we're
going to call the distractor for
engineer then we're going to call the
destructor for the base class so things
are going to be happening in reverse
order we will build thanks starting from
the base and then
finish by the most specialized class
which is doing the inheritance and then
we're going to call the destructor for
the most specialized class first and
then the destructor for the most based
class is going to be cold last you
should really make sure you understand
this because sometimes your things are
going to be depending on this order and
you need to understand this and this is
really the main message here that the
structures are ridiculed in the reverse
order
than the constructors
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
see that we can actually reuse names in
our inheritance hierarchy and we're
going to see how that works out in the
next lecture so go ahead and finish up
here and meet me there in this lecture
we're going to see that we can reuse
names in our inheritance hierarchy
and what we mean by that is that we can
have a parent class for example and have
a child class inheriting from the parent
class and have exactly the same names
for the member variables and types or
the same signatures for functions for
example in the parent class you see that
we have a member function called
printfur it is going to be printing some
information we can have a function named
exactly the same in the child class and
c plus plus is going to allow this we
can also do the same things for member
variables for example we have m var
which is of type and we have exactly the
same thing in our child class and c plus
plus is going to allow this now the
problem is if you create an object of
child which method will be called if you
call printvar now
what c plus plus does is it is going to
override or hide
things you have in the base class if you
happen to set up exactly the same thing
in a derived class so for example the
members in our child class are going to
hide the members we had in the base
class and if we call these methods on a
child object we are going to get the
versions in the child class called if we
call these methods on a parent object we
are going to get the parent version
called and we're going to see the data
in the parent class printed out this is
the message here it is possible to use
the same names in both parent and child
classes and if you do that things in
child classes are going to hide or
override what we had in the parent class
this is the message i want to convey
here and here is a simple example to
drive home how you can use these things
for example we can create a child object
using this syntax here
and if we call a method on the child
object this is going to call the method
in child but it is possible to force the
compiler to call the version in the base
class and you're going to see this
syntax used somewhere in your code out
there so the syntax is to say the object
name you put it up you say the name for
the parent class and then you call the
method using the scope resolution
operator here and this is going to hold
the method in the parent okay now that
you know this we're going to head over
to visual studio code and play with this
a little more here we are in our working
folder the current project is reused
symbols and inheritance we are going to
just grab the template files because we
are going to be building things from
scratch here and we're going to put in
our files no big deal here and we can
open this in visual studio code this is
going to give us a bare minimum main cpp
file we can clean it up a little bit and
we're going to set up our parent class
let's do that pretty fast we're going to
say parent and set up the header and
we're going to set up the implementation
cpp file we are going to set up the
header file and this is going to do
everything we want we have a constructor
which is really defaulted here so let's
say default and we cannot default the
destructor can we default it let's do
this and see what happens and we don't
really need to do anything in the cpp
file we can leave it empty this is not
going to hurt anything and with this we
can create parent objects let's do that
we're going to say
we're going to hop over to the main cpp
file and include current and make sure
that we can use that and we're going to
create a parent object let's do that
we're going to say parent p1 and say
p1 print values we can do that and we
can work and run this program i think it
is going to work just fine okay the
build is good we can clear or we can set
up a powershell window and a clear
and run rooster this is going to say the
value in parent is 100 which is what we
have by default here we have a simple
member variable which is of ant type it
is protected because we want it to be
inherited and we have a bunch of
constructors here we have a constructor
which is going to take a value but we're
not going to use that here the default
is just fine you can use that if you
want and we have a member function which
is going to print the value in parent
now that this is working we can set up a
child class which is going to be
inheriting from the parent class here so
let's do that we're going to set up the
child header file child dot h and we're
going to set up a cpp file for that that
cpp so we are going to put the data in
the header file again it is nothing
complicated it is just a simple class
which is going to be inheriting from
parent and we are going to have our own
member variable which is going to
eclipse what we had in the parent so the
names here must be the same m a member
of r if we go in parent it is m member
for and what we have in child is going
to eclipse what we had in the parent
class in other words if we print the
member variable in child we're going to
see 1000 printed out here we want to see
100 that we have in the parent printed
out hopefully this is going to drive the
point home that if you have members
named exactly the same
what you have in your derived classes is
going to eclipse or hide what we had in
the parent class this is the message
here but even if this is the case c plus
plus allows us to specify that we want
to grab the data in parent from a child
object for example in our show values
method we can print the value in child
directly using m member war but we can
also specify that we want the value in
the parent class because even if this is
a child object it has a current part of
it so we can access the data in parent
and print that if the data happens to be
accessible from our derived class and
that's why we set up our member variable
to be protected for it to be accessible
in our derived classes this is going to
allow us to print something like this
and this is going to really work now
that we have this in place we can go in
the main cpp file
and only include the child we can do
that and we're going to create a child
object or we can just take out
everything here
and adjust putting the code we can use
to play with this things we can create
the child object
and on this child we can print for we're
going to see that the data is going to
be printed out but we can also use this
syntax to print the data in the parent
part of us and we're going to see that
the data is printed out we can also show
the values and make sure we see this
from a member function of the child
class this is going to call this member
and we're going to get to the value in
child and we're going to get the value
in parent printed out on the console now
that we have this we can actually try
and work this we're going to use gcc to
do that
we're going to see that we're going to
finish building with errors what is the
problem here we have an undefined
reference to child destructor
we didn't put in a definition for the
child destructor so let's go there
and default it we can do that we're
going to say equals default and the
compiler is going to generate one for us
and now if we build we're going to build
with gcc again the bolt is going to be
good you can clear and run rooster and
we're going to see that the value in
child is 33 because we passed that in
explicitly and this is going to call the
constructor we have in child that
happens to be this guy here and you see
that we are really keeping things simple
we are not calling the base constructor
here the compiler is just going to call
the default constructor we have in
parent here and this is going to just
work the main message here is that you
can set up member variables and member
functions named exactly the same way in
the parent class and in child classes
and what you have in your derived
classes is going to hide what we have in
our current classes so if we call a
method on a child object for example
like we are doing here this is going to
call the method in child but we still
have the ability to call data in the
parent part of us and this is what we do
here i would like to welcome you in this
new chapter where we're going to be
learning about polymorphism and
polymorphism is the setup we can do in
our c plus plus programs
to use a base pointer and manage derived
objects suppose we have an inheritance
hierarchy like we have here we have
shaped as our base class and we can
inherit from oval and create a circle
class imagine that we can create all
kinds of crazy shapes that inherit from
shape in our simplest path program for
example we have a rectangle class we
have a triangle class we have all kinds
of crazy shapes now if we have this
inheritance hierarchy here is something
we might want to do we might want to set
up a base pointer that is managing a
derived object and set up code like this
for example we say shape pointer and i
set up a pointer variable here and use
this pointer to manage a circle object
that we dynamically allocate for on this
line here we can also do a shape pointer
that is managing a rectangle we can set
up a shape pointer that is managing a
novel object we can really set up a base
pointer that is managing any kind of
object we support in our inheritance
hierarchy now some of you are going to
ask a few questions one of them is going
to be is this even legal c plus plus
syntax and the answer is yes because if
circle is inherited somehow from shape a
circle is really a shape and if
rectangle is inheriting from shape it is
a shape and if we try to assign a circle
to a shape we're going to see that
that's going to work so this is valid c
plus plus syntax and we can do the same
thing using references as we see here we
can set up a reference that is going to
be managing
a circle object that we have through
circle one we can set up a reference to
manage a rectangle that we have in shape
two we can set up a reference to manage
an awful object we can really do all
these things
now some of you are asking
why would we want to do something like
this now try and think about your
inheritance hierarchy here and try to
think about what if you want to
draw this kind of ship for example if
you didn't use polymorphism you would
need to set up all kinds of crazy
methods to draw each kind of object and
we have no way around this because these
are different types if you have a method
that takes a novel and you pass in a
circle that's going to give you a
compiler error but with polymorphism we
can set up a single method which takes a
shape pointer or a shape reference
and we can pass in all kinds of crazy
objects whose class derive from shape so
for example we can pass in the address
of the circle and this function is going
to draw a circle we can pass in the
address of a rectangle this is going to
draw a rectangle we can pass in the
address of a novel and this is going to
draw a novel hopefully you can see how
this is useful we can even do this using
references so if we pass in a rectangle
this is going to draw a rectangle if we
pass in a circle this is going to draw a
circle you get the idea this is one of
the benefits of using polymorphism again
polymorphism is about using base class
pointers or references to manage derived
objects in our inheritance hierarchies
another benefit of polymorphism is to
allow us to be able to store
different kinds of objects in a single
collection remember an array can store
objects of different types if you say
tap an end array and try to store in a
string or a double you're going to get a
compiler error because that's not
allowed so if you have an array that is
going to store circles you can't put in
a novel you can't put in a rectangle you
can put in a star you can't really do
that because an array by design is going
to store objects of the same type but we
can avoid this limitation using
polymorphism again we can set up an
array that is going to store base class
pointers and we can store in all kinds
of crazy objects whose class derived
from this base class here so here we can
store in a circle object we can store in
a novel we can store in any kind of
object that is part of our inheritance
hierarchy with the base class as shape
and this is going to work and this is
going to be using polymorphism for
example if you look through this
collection calling the joe method for
the first element this is going to call
the draw method on the circle for the
second element we're going to call the
draw method on a novel and this is going
to be
really cool this is something we can
achieve with polymorphism and i want to
back up a little bit and talk about what
is really meant by polymorphism
polymorphism really means multiple forms
and in my opinion what this means is
that the base class pointer or base
class reference can take multiple forms
at one point it might be managing a
circle at one point it might be managing
a rectangle at one point it might be
managing a novel object so it is a basic
pointer but it can take multiple forms
because it can be managing multiple
kinds of objects whose class are part of
our inheritance hierarchy this is what
we mean by polymorphism so again the
idea is that we can use the base class
pointer or reference to manage all kinds
of crazy objects in our program and this
is going to have many benefits as we are
about to experience in this chapter here
i am really excited to be explaining
this to you this is one of the most
powerful features in c plus plus we are
going to start in the next lecture and
show you that you don't get polymorphism
by default in c plus plus and what you
get is static binding go ahead and
finish up here and meet me there
manage derived objects in our c plus
plus program hopefully this is going to
give you a clear idea on why we might
need to do this so let's look at our
classes that we're going to be using
here we're going to set up a shape class
which is going to be representing our
shapes this is going to be our base
class that's the basic use for this here
it has a simple member variable which is
going to store the description for our
shape it is also going to have our draw
method which is really not going to draw
anything it is just going to say the
description for our shape here once we
have this shape we can create other
shapes from it for example we can create
a novel class which is going to be
representing a shape like this it is
going to have two member variables one
is going to be mx radius the other is
going to be m y radius this may
represent
the radiuses for our oval here for
example the x radius might be something
like this the y radius might be
something like this and this is how
we're going to be representing
this shape here we also have a draw
method which is going to print the
information about this shape here it is
going to say the description that we're
going to be inheriting publicly from
shape but it is also going to say the
radius information for this shape it is
going to give us the x radius and the y
radius here and we have a bunch of
constructors here we have a default
constructor which is really not going to
do anything we also have a constructor
that is going to be taking two
parameters to forward the data in our
member variables here this is the kind
of class we're going to set up in our
program we also have another derived
class from oval and this is going to be
a circle class it is going to be a
specialization on oval in which both x
and y radius are equal so the x radius
is going to be something like this and
the y radius is going to be something
like this and both of these are going to
be equal so this is going to give us a
circle shape we also have a draw method
which is going to print the description
and the radius we can really pick any
radius we can pick the x radius we can
pick the y radius they are really going
to be the same because they are equal
for our circle shape we also have a
simple constructor which is going to
take the radius and we are going to be
using this radius
to forward the data to our oval part of
us and we're going to be setting this as
both x and y radius this is the setup we
have here okay now that we have our
inheritance hierarchy we're going to try
and use it and really explore the idea
of static binding in c plus plus
inheritance hierarchies so here we are
trying to create simple
objects of our classes we have a shape
object we have an oval object and we
have a circle object we are going to go
through a base pointer and try to manage
our objects here
in our first line we're going to set up
a shape pointer and we're going to store
in the address of shape one and what we
would want in our c plus plus program is
that if we call the draw method on this
shape pointer we would want the shape
draw method to be called because we have
a shape object stored in our base
pointer here or in other words we are
using a base pointer to manage this
object in memory down here we store a
novel object in our shape pointer or in
other words we're going to be using this
base pointer to manage an actual oval
object in memory and the setup we want
is that if we call the draw method on
this shape pointer now we are going to
get the oval draw method to be called
this is the setup we want
and down here we have another example
where we are using this base pointer to
manage a circle object we are going to
store the address of the circle object
in this base pointer this is how we do
this and when we call
a draw method on this base pointer we
want the circle draw method to be called
so with polymorphism what we really want
is to call a method on the base pointer
and get the most specific possible
method called on our pointer this is the
setup we want but this is not what we
get by default in c plus plus if we
happen to do this and run our program as
is now with the current knowledge that
we have on the first line here we're
going to get the shape draw method
called this is what we want but on the
second example here we will see that we
see the shape draw method also called
and on this line we will also see that
we get the shape draw method to be
called this is not what we want and this
is static binding so what is happening
here is the compiler is looking at the
type of the pointer and it is using that
to decide which draw method to call so
the compiler is so the compiler is
basically saying i have a shape pointer
so i am going to call the joe method on
the shape class down here it is going to
see that it also has a shape pointer and
it is going to call the draw method on
shape and down here it is going to see
that it has a shape pointer and it is
going to call the jaw method on the
shape class this is what static binding
is all about the compiler is going to
resolve the joe method statically and
what that means is that the compiler is
going to look at the type of the pointer
that we have and it is going to use that
to decide which joe method to call in
our inheritance hierarchy so this is the
default and it is called static binding
in c plus plus we also get the same
behavior if we try to use a base
reference to manage our actual object in
memory here we have the same kinds of
objects we had in a previous slide and
we are using a base reference to manage
our object and what we really want is
that if we go through a base reference
to call our draw method we will get the
most specific draw method called so if
our base reference is managing a shape
we will get the shape draw method called
if our base reference is managing an
alpha object we want the oval draw
method to be called here and if our base
reference is managing a circle object we
want the circle joe method called here
this is what we want but again the
compiler is just going to look at the
type of the reference so for the first
line here it's going to say i have a
shape reference so i am going to call
the shape draw method that's what we're
going to get here on the second line
here it's going to say uh-huh i have a
shape reference so i will call
the draw method of the shape class
that's what we're going to see here by
default and on this line here it is
going to say i have a shape reference so
i am going to call the draw method on
the shape class and this is the behavior
we get by default and this is static
binding in action okay so now that we
have seen what static binding is all
about let's re-examine the idea of why
we need polymorphism and i am going to
give you a simple example here suppose
we have a bunch of shapes we manage in
our programs and we want to draw all
these shapes if we want to draw a circle
with the current setup we have we would
set up a draw circle method if we want
to draw a novel we would need to set up
a draw over method and this will call
our circle draw method and this will
call our oval joe method this is going
to do what we want but try to think
about this if we have 100 shapes in our
program we will need to set up 100 such
methods and this is a mess i don't think
you want to do something like this
and we have another simple case that i
want you to consider suppose we want to
store all these objects in collections
and we're going to use an array to try
and drive this point home here if we
want to store these guys in collections
we will need to set up different
collections because as we have it now we
can't store different types in an array
so what we would need to do now is to
set up an array for circles and set up
an array for ovals and do more
collections for different kinds of
shapes that we support in our program
and if we want to draw them we have no
choice but to set up different kinds of
loops and each of these loops is going
to be looping on each of these
collections here hopefully you can see
that this is by design we don't want to
do this we want to set up something that
is really easier to manage in our
program and polymorphism was
and polymorphism and c plus plus was
designed to exactly solve this kind of
problem
what we really want in our c plus plus
programs is to set up one draw method
for example we can give it a base
pointer and it doesn't matter which kind
of object we pass it when we call this
we will get that method to be called at
run time when we actually need to draw
this shape if we pass in a circle this
is going to draw the draw method on a
circle if we pass in a novel it will
call the draw method on our oval object
if we pass in a rectangle for example it
is going to call the draw method on our
rectangle object this is what we want we
also want the same kind of setup if for
example our functions are taking
reference and this is what we're going
to get this is what we want with
polymorphism and this is really going to
improve on the design that we had
earlier when we needed to set up a
specific method for each shape and we
would end up with hundreds of draw
methods and that's really bad it's not
manageable this is also going to solve
our problem with collections
we really need to set up one collection
which is going to be taking into account
all the ships that we manage in our
inheritance hierarchy so the setup we do
is something like this we're going to
set up an array that is going to be
storing pointers to shape and we can
store in the address of a shape we can
store in the address of a novel we can
store in the address of the circle
because if you really think about it a
circle is a shape a novel is the shape
and the shape is the shape so this is
going to work and when we get to loop
through this collection and call the
draw method for the first item here we
will call the draw method on the shape
for the second element here we will call
the joe method on the oval object and
for the third element here we will call
the draw method on our circle object and
we will draw a shape a novel and a
circle with just one loop and this is
really cool this is the design we want
now this is not the default behavior we
get in our c plus plus classes if we set
up an inheritance hierarchy
with our draw methods what we get by
default is static binding but we will
see how we can get dynamic binding or
polymorphism in the next lecture for
this one we're going to explore static
binding and we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with us a
little more here we are in our working
folder the current project is static
binding with inheritance we are going to
grab our template files this is going to
be our starting point here we're going
to put in these files and i am going to
put in our classes to save time
if you want you can download these
classes from the attached
resource section on this lecture you're
going to find them and you can use them
as a starting point this is going to
save us a few seconds because we don't
really want to type these classes you
already know how to create classes if
you made it this far in the course so i
am going to drag this and drop here to
open in visual studio code and this is
going to give us a good starting point
here we have a base class which is our
shape class it is going to have a simple
member variable which is going to be the
description one thing i think we need to
improve on this is to use a string view
to pass our parameter here
so let's include string view we can
include that here we're going to say
include string view because we are using
modern c plus plus and we're going to
change this to be an sdd string view by
value we can do this okay so we have our
class here and we have a draw method
which is really not going to do anything
special it's going to just print the
description here and we're going to see
it printed out on the output stream
if we look at the cpp file we just have
an implementation of our constructor and
we have a destructor we're going to fix
our parameter here to make it an std
string view let's look at our oval class
it is going to be
deriving publicly from shape
and we have a bunch of member variables
here two to be exact one is going to be
the x radius the other is going to be
our y radius we have a constructor here
which is going to be taking three
parameters two parameters for the data
for our radius here and we have a
third parameter which is going to store
our description data we're going to also
change this to bstd string view and this
is going to do we have a draw method
which is going to be printing the
description and our radius data and this
is really it we don't need anything
fancy here let's look at our oval cpp
file it is going to have the
implementation for our constructor
and our destructor here
we just need to change the type for our
description here and make this an sdd
string view let's do this and we will
look at our circle class which is going
to be inheriting from
publicly it won't have any member
variable because it's just going to
forward the data to the over portoverse
it doesn't really need to do any other
specialization but what we need is a
method which is going to return the
radius because we want to print that
here so we can head over in our oval
class and set up a protected section
which is going to give us these methods
here so i'm just going to put them in
here to save on some time it is
protected because we want this to be
usable in derived classes but we don't
want this usable from the outside this
is the setup we can achieve by making
these guys protected here get x rad is
going to return the x radius get y rad
is going to return the y radius they are
const because we don't intend for this
to modify our object and if we go in our
circle class this is going to work now
we will be able to print our
information on our circle object and we
will see on our output stream if we look
at the implementation of our circle
class it is nothing complicated it is
just going to take the double radius and
it is going to forward the data to the
oval part of us and our description here
will need to change
to take into account that we want to use
std string view here so let's change
this to bhd string view we can do that
and we are going to head over in our cpp
file and change that as well std string
view you can do that and now our classes
are really complete we can head over in
our main cpp file we can clean that up a
little bit and we're going to remove
what we don't need here
we are going to include our classes so
we're going to include shape let's do
that
we are going to put in oval let's do
that oval dot h and we are going to put
in circle and we are going to create
objects of these classes and try to
print their information so we're going
to set up a shape called the shape one
we're going to set up a novel called
oval one we're going to set up a circle
called circle one and we're going to see
what kind of information we see
if we try to call the job method again
in shape the draw method is just going
to say that we are calling shape joe
in alvo we are going to say that we are
drawing an oval and we're going to say
the description and the radius in circle
we're going to say that we are calling
the draw method on the circle object and
say the description and the radius here
this is the information we want so we
are going to try and build this program
using gcc our favorite compiler you can
really use any compiler you have your
hands on but we are going to use gcc
here because it is our favorite and
we're going to have a bunch of errors
what it is that we have here what is it
that we have here let's go in shape
header
at line 4 and see what we have and we
have a j here that we don't want let's
take this out and we're going to build
it and we're going to pass this through
gcc and the bolt is going to be good we
can bring up a powershell window to run
our program let's run rooster and we're
going to see that shape draw was called
drawing shape one you see we have just
created shape one here and we are
printing its information
we are going to call the oval drill
method and we're going to print
the information on that you see that it
is over one here and we're going to put
out our radius data x radius is going to
be 2 as we specified here y radius is
going to be 3.5 and this is our
information we are also going to call
the draw method on our circle object
this is what we get and we're going to
say we are drawing circle 1 and the
radius is going to be 3 3 this is our
information here but we don't want to go
through direct objects to manage our
data here what we want is to either go
through base pointers or base references
so we are going to set up a shape
pointer let's do that we're going to say
shift because that's our base class and
we're going to say
shape ptr to represent our pointer and
we're going to store in the address of
shape one we can do something like this
and that's really see what is happening
we're going to comment out our calls to
draw methods here and we're going to see
what happens so if we say shape ptr and
call the draw method we can do that
let's try and build our program
we're going to pass this through gcc
you're going to see that it is going to
work and it is going to do what we
expect if we run this program here you
can clear and run rooster we're going to
see that shape draw was called and we
are going to be drawing shape one here
this is what we expect but if we go down
and say we don't want to call the draw
method here we are going to store in
let's say shape ptr and we're going to
store in the address of our over one
object
and we want to call the draw method here
now if you do this as we saw in the
slides what we really want
is to get the draw method on our actual
oval object called and if we will for
example drawing things on the screen we
would draw a novel this is what we want
here but this is not what we're going to
get you're going to see that we still
get the
job method from the shape class called
and it is going to and it is going to
say drawing over one let's try and build
this program and i really want you to
see this so the builder is good we can
clear and run rooster you're going to
see
row even if we are storing again
a novel
object so this is the default behavior
we get and this is static binding that
we get by default in our inheritance
hierarchies so what the compiler is
really going to do here it's going to
look at the type of the pointer that we
have here it is going to say i have a
shape pointer so i am going to call the
jaw method on the shape type that i have
in my pointer here and we are going to
see
that this is calling the draw method on
our shape and this is not what we want
in most cases we are going to see that
we get the same behavior if we store an
a circle object let's do that we're
going to say shift pointer and we're
going to store in the address of our
circle one and then we're going to call
our draw method on our shape pointer
again this is going to draw a shape it's
not going to draw a circle that we
really are managing with our base
pointer here and some of you must be
thinking
why are we able to store circle pointers
for example in a shape well a circle is
a shape according to our inheritance
hierarchy if we take a closer look again
here you're going to see that oval is
going to be inheriting from shape
and the circle is going to be inheriting
from oval so from what we learned in the
last chapter
oval has a shape part in it and the
circle has a novel part in it which in
turn is going to have a shaped board in
it so from this understanding it
shouldn't really be surprising that we
are able to manage a
novel object with a shape pointer or the
fact that we are able to manage a circle
object
using a shape pointer this is why we are
able to do something like this okay so i
hope this is super clear but again we
are not getting the default behavior
that we want but we will see how we can
achieve that in the next lecture for now
i really want you to understand what
static binding is all about and it is
the fact that the compiler is going to
look at the type of the pointer here and
use that to decide which method it is
going to be calling
in our inheritance hierarchy the
compiler for example is going to see
that we have a circle object stored n at
lineup 25 here but when it wants to
decide which joe version to call it is
going to look at the type of this
pointer here and it is going to use that
to decide which draw method to call and
in this case it is going to call the
shape version because the type of this
pointer is shape okay so i really hope
this is super clear here we are going to
get the same behavior if we try to
manage our objects using references for
example if we go through a shape
reference let's do that we're going to
say shape reference and say shape ref
and we are going to store in shape one
for example let's do that
and we want to call the draw method on
ship reference let's do that so let's
call the joe method and you're going to
see that we will get the shape method
called
and this is really making sense because
we have a shape object
managed by this reference here so if we
build our program let's do that we're
going to pass this through gcc
you're going to see that we get what we
expect the build is going to be good
we're going to clear and run rooster and
we see shape drill called this is what
we want but if we use this reference to
manage derived object for example let's
put in over one we can do that we're
going to see that we don't get the most
specific draw method for oval here
called we will still get the method
for a shape called let's build and show
you this this is static binding again
okay the build is good we can clear and
run rooster we're going to see that
shape draw it is drawing we don't get
the ovo draw method called we get shape
drill method again the compiler is going
to look at the type of this reference by
default and it is going to use that to
decide which draw method to call if we
even put in a circle we are going to get
the same behavior let's build with gcc
the bolt is good we can clear and run
rooster we see that shape draw is called
and this is really not
what we want okay so this is static
binding and it is the default behavior
we get if we have an inheritance
hierarchy with the same method spread
across each derived class we're going to
get the shape version called even if
what we are really managing with a shape
pointer or a shape reference is a
derived object i really want you to
understand this now let's see why this
is really badly designed by default in c
plus plus if you happen to need to pass
ship parameters to functions for example
we might do something like this we might
need a function to draw a circle we
might need a function to draw a novel
and if you happen to have 100 objects
you can draw in your program you have no
choice but to set up 100 drawing methods
or functions this is really bad design
you don't want to do something like this
so what you would do in your program for
example is go down
and say drawing
and you would say for example draw
circle and pass in a circle and say draw
oval do we have a draw or full function
let's see yes we have that we can go
down and say draw oval and pass in our
oval one this is going to work just fine
but hopefully you can see that this is
bad design if you have a lot of shapes
in your program this is going to quickly
become and manageable and you don't want
to do something like this what we want
is to be able
to only have one method and get to the c
plus plus runtime to resolve which one
is called at runtime when we get to pass
our actual objects and we will only have
one function which is going to take into
account hundreds of shapes that we might
potentially have in our c plus plus
program this is going to be much easier
to manage and we will actually be able
to achieve this in the next lecture so
stay tuned for that another problem with
us is if you happen to need to store
these shapes in collections if you need
to set up something like this you will
have no choice but to set up different
collections for each type for example we
might set up a collection for a circle a
collection for oval and here we are just
using arrays to model our collections
this is really bad design if you happen
to have 100 shapes in your program you
will set up 100 such collections and the
only difference is that they are just
different types and this is really bad
design because even if they are
different types they are related and
they are all shapes in our c plus plus
program and what we really want is to
set up one collection which is going to
take into account all these kinds of
shapes that we might have in our c plus
plus program and we will be able to
achieve this again in the next lecture
but the whole point of this lecture was
to show you static binding that we get
by default with our inheritance
hierarchies static binding may be bad if
you really are managing a lot of related
objects in your c plus plus program
and all these objects have the same
method
that each derived class is specializing
but you want the most specialized method
to be called on the actual object that
you are managing with a base pointer or
a base reference hopefully this is super
clear i apologize this lecture turned
out to be really long but i wanted you
to make this super clear and everything
else we do in the reminder of this
chapter is really going to fall in place
so make sure you understand this and if
you have a problem do you ask me i will
do the best i can to help you out this
is really all i had to share in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this
lecture in the next one we're going to
show you how you can achieve dynamic
binding using virtual functions in c
plus plus
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to see
how we can achieve dynamic binding or
polymorphism
using virtual functions in our
inheritance hierarchies in the last
lecture we had a hierarchy like this
where the base class was shaped we had
an overclass which was publicly deriving
or inheriting from shape and we had a
circle class which was publicly
inherited from over and the problem we
had was that if we happen to be managing
oval or circle objects using
shape pointers or shape references we
don't get the correct methods called if
we call the draw method
on our base pointer or base reference
and this was really bad and this is
something we want in practical c plus
plus programs i am here to tell you in
this lecture that you can just achieve
that
by doing a tiny modification on your
inheritance hierarchy all you need to do
is to mark the methods you need to be
dynamically resolved
virtual and we do that by inserting this
virtual keyword in front of our function
so we're going to do that on our shape
class we're going to do that on our over
class and we're going to do that on our
circle class once we do this the c plus
plus compiler is going to know i want to
be looking at the type of the pointer or
reference to know which kind of method
to call and my inheritance hierarchy if
i happen to be using a base pointer or a
base reference to manage a derived
object and we're going to be making this
super clear in a minute and if you are
lost please bear with me you're going to
understand so let's do this we're going
to modify our shape class and change our
draw method to be virtual
as you see here we're going to head over
in our oval class we're going to modify
our draw method and mark it to be
virtual using the virtual keyword here
and we're going to move in our circle
class and change it to be virtual as you
see down here this is really all we need
to do
from what we had in the last lecture and
this is going to be magic let's look at
what we can achieve now we're going to
set up three objects shape oval and
circle as you see here and we're going
to be calling our method which is going
to be taking references and we're going
to see that we get the correct most
specific method called so for example
here we will call the shape joe down
here we will call the oval draw method
because we just passed in a novel object
and on the third line here we will get
the circle joe method called and we will
see it printed out on the console this
is really cool this is what we want to
achieve if we want to call our methods
that take pointers we can do that and on
the first line here we will call shape
draw on the second line here we will
call overdraw and on the third line here
we will call circuit draw this is what
we want to achieve and if we happen to
be setting up a roll base pointer like
we do here and store in
a derived object like this or another
way to say this if we happen to be using
this base pointer to manage a derived
object and we call the draw method on
the base pointer the compiler is going
to know that it will need to resolve
this draw method dynamically the reason
is this is a virtual method and if a
method is virtual the compiler want to
do
static binding like we did in the last
lecture the compiler is going to be
doing dynamic binding and with dynamic
binding the compiler is not going to
look at the type of the pointer it is
going to look at the type of the actual
object that the pointer is managing and
this is going to give us the behavior
that we wanted starting from the last
lecture okay now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is polymorphism with
virtual functions we are going to be
reusing the code from the last lecture
because that's going to give us
everything we want
we will leave out the
binary file here which is rooster and
we're going to copy everything we want
we're going to put that in the current
project and we're going to open this in
visual studio code we are going to have
our main cpp file with a bunch of
methods here
and we will just need to modify this a
little bit to achieve dynamic binding as
we saw in the slides all we need to do
is to mark all these draw methods as
virtual so we're going to say virtual
void draw in the shape class we're going
to go in the oval class and do that
we're going to mark our method as
virtual and we are going to go in our
circle class and mark our draw method as
virtual let's do that and at the moment
we do this we're going to get dynamic
binding behavior in our inheritance
hierarchy here and this is really cool
so let's go back and try to play with
what we had before i am going to comment
out everything we had and we're going to
be doing things in step here let's go
through the code that uses base pointers
because
that's where we started out from in the
last lecture
and we are going to
mark that here let's put in some space
to make it easy to follow so we are
going to uncomment the line here that
calls the draw method when we have a
shape object stored in our base pointer
or when we are using a base pointer to
manage a shape object here we can also
comment out all these lines because we
don't want this to do anything
and let's see yes this is what we want
we are setting up our shapes and we are
using a base pointer to manage an actual
shape object and if we call the draw
method we expect this to call
shape draw and this is what we're going
to get let's build our program we're
going to pass this through gcc our
favorite compiler the build is going to
be good we can bring up a powershell
window we can use to play with us if we
call rooster we're going to see that
shape draw is called and we are drawing
shape one now if we change this to
manage an actual oval object we can do
that we can do that through this line
here and we expect this to call overdraw
and because the draw method is now
virtual this will use dynamic binding
again with dynamic binding we are
telling the compiler don't look at the
type of the base pointer look at the
type of the actual object that the
pointer is managing and the compiler is
going to see that this object is a novel
object and it will call
the oval version of the draw method here
and this is really cool this is what we
want let's run the task to build with
gcc again the world is going to be good
as you see here we can clear
and if we run booster look at this
overdraw calls and we are going to be
drawing our oval object and this is the
data we have inside we can use this
radius data to draw this on the screen
if that's what we are after in our c
plus plus program and this is really
cool we can even use our base pointer to
manage a circle object we can do that
and if we do that and call the joe
method because this draw method is now
virtual the compiler will note that it
doesn't need to look at the type of the
pointer that we are using to manage our
object
the compiler is going to look at the
type of the actual object that the base
pointer is managing and in this case it
happens to be a circle object so here we
will call circle draw and this is going
to draw a circle on the screen and this
is really going to be super cool so
let's pass this through gcc
and we're going to see this in action
the build is going to be good we can
clear and run rooster and you see that
we are drawing a circle and this is
really cool and just using virtual
functions we can really achieve powerful
features and you see that this wasn't
really hard to achieve all we had to do
was to mark our inherited methods as a
virtual and this is going to tell the
compiler to do dynamic binding and this
is going to be super cool let's see that
we can also achieve the same thing using
base references i am not going to run
the code where we are using a
base reference i am not going to be
running the code where we are using a
base reference to manage
a base
object because that's going to be really
boring but what we can do is put in an
awful object for example you can say
over one and say shape ref and call the
draw method again this is dynamic
binding because the draw method is
virtual so the compiler is not going to
look at the type of the reference to
decide which version of the draw method
to call it is going to look at the
actual object that this reference is
managing and it is going to see that the
type of the object is awful so c plus
plus is going to call the oval version
of the draw method that's what we're
going to get if we run this program here
let's build and see this we're going to
pass this through gcc the voltage should
be good as we see here we are going to
clear and run rooster you see we are
drawing oval if we happen to be using
this to manage our circle object let's
do that
we will see that we will get the circle
method called okay let's build and we're
going to pass this through gcc to do
that the both is going to be good we can
clear and run rooster you see that we
are drawing a circle because our base
pointer is now managing a circle object
now because we are using dynamic binding
or late binding as some people call it
we can really do all kinds of crazy
things the first thing we can achieve is
set up one single method which is really
going to draw any kind of shape we throw
at it so let's do something like this
we're going to say void and we're going
to say draw shape and it is going to
take a shape pointer let's say s and the
only thing we're going to do in this
function and say s draw this is going to
call the draw method on whatever
parameter that we pass in here
and watch this if we go down here and
uncomment this section on drawing shapes
if we say draw and pass in a circle for
example or let's pass an oval and do
this one level and to do this level by
level we're going to pass in over one
and we should pass an address because
this is taking a pointer let's so let's
do this and if we build and run this
program let's see what happens here
we're going to build with gcc the world
is going to be good as you see here if
we clear and run rooster you see
and let's take out this thing using base
references here because this is just
going to confuse us we're going to build
again and i use gcc for this the build
is going to be good within clear and run
rooster you see oval drill because we
are passing in a novel object if we pass
in our shape let's say shape one for
example we're going to build the book is
going to be good as you see here if we
clear and run rooster we're going to see
shape draw if we pass in circle let's do
that
and the bold again we're going to build
with gcc we're going to clear and run
rooster you're going to see that circle
draw is called and this is really cool
we can only use a single method and this
method is going to take any shape we
throw at it and it is going to draw it
if we happen to be having 100 kinds of
shapes in our program we can just for
example loop through a collection
containing those shapes and if we call
the draw method on any shape we store in
our collection we're going to get the
correct shape drone and this is super
cool this is really powerful and i hope
you are excited to be able to achieve
this in c plus plus now we can also
achieve the same thing by using a method
that takes a reference for example so we
can say void joe shape let's say v1 and
we're going to pass a reference
we can say const and pass a reference
and say sr to say ship reference we can
do that and we're going to say sjo we're
going to call the jaw method on this
reference and let's see what happens if
we try this out let's say sr that's what
we should say here and this is going to
be taken by our visual studio code
editor if we go in here and change this
to say
draw shape v1 we can pass in shape one
we can do that because this is taking a
reference now
if we build with gcc we are going to see
that the world is good we can clear
let's clear we're going to run the
rooster this is going to call shape draw
because we are using a reference to
manage a shaped object we can also pass
it over one and we're going to build
again and see how this works the bolt is
going to be good we can clear and run
rooster we're going to say overdraw and
we're going to see our information here
if we pass in our circle object
and the bolt we're going to pass this
through gcc the bolt is going to be good
we can clear and run rooster this is
going to draw a circle for us this is
really cool we have one method again
that is taking a parameter by reference
but we can use this method to draw any
kind of shape in our inheritance
hierarchy this is going to work really
well and it is doing dynamic binding
which is powered by virtual functions we
are using in our inheritance hierarchy
here you should really keep this in mind
now let's go back and see if we can even
use row pointers to do stuff i am going
to comment this out and i am going to
say roll pointers because i want you to
see something we're going to set up a
shape pointer we're going to say shape
ptr
do we have that on top here let's see if
we do
yes we have shape ptr so let's say shape
ptr
and pass it a novel object we're going
to pass a novel again and we're going to
pass the address of 01 this is going to
do we can call the draw method and get
it called polymorphically
or get it called using dynamic binding
we can say shape ptr
and say draw this is going to call the
correct version but one thing i want you
to see is that if a method is not
polymorphic or if a method is not
virtual
you want to get it called using
polymorphism for example if we go to our
oval class we're going to see that we
have a bunch of getters let's go in and
make them public so that they are
callable from the outside and if we try
and get this called
polymorphically or using dynamic binding
that's not going to work let's do that
we're going to say get x rad and the
reason we might want to do something
like this is because we have this method
here
and it is set up on our oval class
so because we are using a base pointer
to manage a novel object some of you
might think uh-huh i might be able to
call this method because i am able to
call the job method which is also in the
public scope of our overclass but that's
not going to work because this method
here is not virtual
dynamic binding or polymorphism is only
going to work if your methods are
virtual and they are set up across your
inheritance hierarchy so this is not
going to work if you try to do something
like this this is going to give you a
compiler error let's try and build and
see the compiler error and we're going
to see an error that says that no such
method on this object let's go here
class shape has no
class shape has no member name to get x
red
because the method is not virtual the
compiler is going to do static binding
and it is going to be using the type of
the pointer which is shaped to resolve
this method and it is going to see that
in shape we don't have a method called
get xrad and the compiler is going to
throw this compiler error here this is
what we get so this is not going to work
and i want you to be aware of this
another thing i want you to see
is that because we are using dynamic
binding now
we don't need we don't need to set up
all kinds of crazy collections to take
into account different shapes that we
have in our c plus plus program what
we're going to do here is use a base
pointer to manage the data that we store
in our array here so all i am going to
do is remove all this dirt here because
this is really dirt you don't want to do
something like that and we're going to
use a base pointer which is a shape
pointer and use that to set up an array
which can handle any kind of shape we
have in our inheritance hierarchy so we
can store it shape objects we can store
it over objects we can store in circle
objects and if we look like we do here
we're going to get the correct method
called and this is going to be super
cool so let's try and run this program
we're going to pass this through gcc why
do we have the red thing here let's
build and see if it goes away maybe this
is visual studio code having a problem
with our code the world is good so
visual studio code was playing with us
we're going to clear and run rooster
you're going to see that we're going to
be looping through this array here and
on the first iteration we're going to
call shape draw because the first thing
is the shape on the second iteration
we're going to call overdraw because the
second thing is a novel and we're going
to
hit the third iteration and call circle
draw because the third thing in this
collection is a circle hopefully you can
see that this is going to simplify our
programs a lot compared to what we were
able to do
in the last lecture and this is really
all i had to share in this lecture
showing you that you can achieve dynamic
binding or polymorphism or late binding
as some people call it using virtual
functions in your inheritance hierarchy
again all we had to do was mark our
member functions as a virtual and the
compiler is going to know that it can
set up dynamic polymorphism for your
types if you happen to be managing them
using a base pointer or a base reference
we are going to stop here in this
lecture and the next one we're going to
learn about slicing and the size of
polymorphic objects
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
explore the size of polymorphic objects
or objects that use dynamic binding and
we're going to learn about the concept
of slicing if you happen to assign a
derived object to a base object we're
going to see how this works out in the
last two lectures we saw that we could
achieve static binding using a setup
like this we can set up an inheritance
hierarchy and we're going to have oval
derive or inherit from shape and we're
going to have circle inherit or derive
from over here and our methods are going
to be row they are not going to be
virtual on anything and this is going to
do static binding if you happen to
manage a derived object through a base
pointer or reference you want to get
dynamic holes you will get static
binding and the compiler will use the
base pointer or base reference to decide
which draw method to call on your object
we also saw that we could achieve
dynamic binding using virtual functions
and all we needed to do was mark our
methods as virtual in our inheritance
hierarchy here and this would give us
polymorphism or dynamic binding but one
thing you should know is that dynamic
binding is not free you're going to be
paying in terms of memory to get all
these cool things we saw in the last
lecture and we're going to be proving
that in this lecture what we're going to
be doing is basically set up our
inheritance hierarchy and we are going
to set that up in such a way that it is
going to be using static binding we're
going to see the sizes we get printed
out here and we're going to use dynamic
binding and compare the sizes and the
constitution is going to be that with
dynamic binding your objects are going
to be much larger because your simplest
plus program will need to keep track of
the information
that allows it to resolve
function calls dynamically and that
information is stored in what we call
virtual tables but i am not going to go
into that here because it is really out
of scope of a course like this but i
want you to be aware of this if you use
dynamic if you use dynamic binding your
objects are going to be much larger okay
the first thing i want to bring your
attention to
is object slicing and we're going to
look at a simple example here we have
our objects we have a shape object we
have an oval object and we have a circle
object and down here we want to assign
our circle object to a shape object
now notice that here we are not using a
pointer or a reference these are just
the row objects that we are assigning to
each other and what the competitor is
basically going to do
it's going to notice that a circle has a
shape according to it and it is going to
strip off the outer layers or in other
words it is going to strip off the
circle layer it is going to strip off
the oval layer and it is going to leave
in the shape part and that's what it is
going to assign to our shape object here
let's visualize this our shape class
looks like what we have here on the left
our oval class has a shape part into it
and our circle is going to have an over
part into it and that oval part is going
to have a shape part of it and this is
the setup that we have here now if we do
our assignment we're going to do
something like this the compiler is
going to see that we are already
assigning a circle
to a shape and the compiler is going to
notice that what we have on the left is
just a shape and we don't have enough
space to store information about oval
and the circle here so what the compiler
is going to do it is going to strip off
all these things that we don't really
need and it is going to leave in only
the
shape part that we can assign on what we
have to the left so it is going to strip
off all these stands and we are going to
be left with something like this and
then what we have on the right is going
to be assigned on the left and we will
have our data stored in our ship to
object and if we try to use it that's
what you're going to get in memory so
this is referred to as slicing again the
compiler is going to notice that it
doesn't really have enough space on the
left to store
everything we have to the right of the
assignment here and it is going to strip
off or slice off
everything we don't need and it is only
going to leave in the shape part and
that's what it is going to assign on our
object that we have on the left of the
assignment operator here and this is
referred to as slicing in c plus plus
terminology i just want you to be aware
of this and we're going to see a lot of
this starting from now now that you know
this we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with this a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is size of
polymorphic objects and slicing we are
going to grab the code from the last
lecture so let's grab everything except
for the binary file we are going to copy
everything and we're going to put that
in the current folder and we're going to
open this little guy in visual studio
code by dragging and dropping here this
is going to give us our project and we
can head over in the main cpp file
and clean up all the mess we got from
the last previous lectures we can also
take out these functions because i don't
think we need them here
and we are going to check out on our
classes notice that we are using dynamic
polymorphism because we have virtual
functions here so if we happen to be
using base pointers or base references
to manage our derived objects we will
get polymorphic results okay the first
thing we want to see is the size of
objects for our classes here because we
are using virtual functions let's head
over in the main cpp file and we're
going to put in a piece of code which is
just going to use the size of operator
to print the sizes
of objects of these classes we can try
to build and run this program we're
going to use gcc here the world is just
going to be good we can bring up a
powershell window we can use to run
these programs
we're going to do that new terminal this
is going to bring us our window here we
can clear and run rooster we're going to
get 40 56 and 56
so you see that these are our sizes so
let's say that with uh dynamic is going
to be 40 for the base class with dynamic
portal morphism we're going to get 56
for the
oval object and we're going to get
dynamic 56 for the
circle object here now we're going to
remove the setup that uses polymorphism
and we're going to see the results that
we get all we need to do is to remove
the virtual keyword here we can comment
it out you can do something like this in
shape and we're going to hop over in
oval and comment out the virtual key
world we can do something like this and
this is going to
work without removing this completely
from our code because we still need to
leave this in as a reference we're going
to hop over to circle and do the same
thing
and now that we have this setup we can
hop over to our main cpp file we're
going to see that we don't have any
squiggly lines of some kind so this is
going to be accepted by the compiler but
if we build and run this program we're
going to see different sizes let's see
if the world is good it is good as you
see here we can clear and run rooster
now you see that with
static binding the base object is 32
bytes the awful object is going to be 48
and hopefully you can see that with
dynamic polymorphism our objects are
going to be much larger because the
compiler has to keep track of the
information that allows it to
dynamically resolve
virtual function calls that's why our
objects are larger with polymorphism and
you should know that you are not getting
polymorphic results for free you are
going to be paying in terms of much more
memory that you use for your objects in
your c plus plus programs this is the
first thing i want you to see in this
lecture the second thing i want you to
be aware of is the concept of slicing
and this is going to happen if you
happen to take a raw
derived object and assign that to a row
based object let's do something like
that we are going to create a circle
object and then we're going to say shape
and say shape here and we're going to
say equals circle one
this is something we could do
but notice that the compiler is not
giving us any kind of compiler error
because we can assign a circle to a
shape because a circle is really a shape
but from what we know in our inheritance
hierarchy a circle is really much more
than a row shape a circle has awful
information in it and it also has circle
information in it so it is really much
larger and much wider than a shape
object but the compiler is going to see
that we are trying to assign a circle to
a shape and it is going to be smart
enough to know
that we don't really need oval and
circle information in our shape object
that we are storing here so the compiler
is going to slice off circle and oval
information and it is going to leave in
shape information and that's the only
thing we will be able to use with this
shape variable that we have in our c
plus plus program so if we say shape
drill you can try to guess what we are
going to get and let's go back and
re-enable polymorphism because some of
you might think we are going to get
polymorphic results
with this setup here that's not what
we're going to get because we are not
going through bezel references or base
pointers to
do what we are doing in this example on
slicing here so because we are not using
base references or base pointers in this
line here the compiler is going to see
that these are raw objects and it is
going to do slicing and slice of things
we don't need in our shape variable
that we are setting up on line 16 here
so if we call the draw method this is
going to call shape draw
it is not going to do dynamic
polymorphism here you should be aware of
this if you're not using the base
pointers or references and you hope to
get dynamic polymorphism results i hate
to break it to you but you're going to
be disappointed because the compiler is
going to slice off derived class
information and all you're going to be
left with is base class information here
that's why this is going to call ship
draw let's build and run and really make
you see this this is going to go through
gcc our favorite compiler the bullet is
going to be good we cannot clear and run
rooster you're going to see that it is
going to say shape draw even if we try
to assign a circle to a shape here this
is going to disappoint us because this
is really going to slice off circle and
oval information
and it is just going to leave in the
shape nucleus that we have in our circle
object here
if i can say it like that this is really
all i had to share in this lecture i
hope you found it interesting we are
going to stop here in this lecture in
the next one we're going to see what
happens if we try to store polymorphic
objects in collections
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
explore what happens if you try to
directly store polymorphic objects in a
collection like an array
in the last lecture we have seen that if
you assign a derived object to a base
object
the data from the derived object is
going to be basically sliced off if you
assign an oval to a shape the oval part
of the object is going to be sliced off
and we're going to be left with only
shaped data that we assigned to our
shape object we saw that this was
referred to as slicing in c plus plus
and the same is going to happen if you
assign a circle object to a shape the
circle information is going to be sliced
off
then the oval information is also going
to be sliced off and we're going to be
left with the inner shape part
that we assign to our shape object here
now i want you to see that this can
happen indirectly in ways that you might
not expect and we are going to use our
inheritance hierarchy again the base
class is going to be shape we're going
to inherit from that and get oval and
we're going to inherit from oval and get
our circle class here
so let's look at a piece of code here we
are creating a bunch of objects we have
a bunch of circles and ovals and we are
setting up an array that is going to
directly store shape objects
but what we are doing is storing our
pre created objects in our array here
and from what you already know if you
store objects in an array like this this
is going to create copies even if you
can't see that directly so what we have
in our array here is not dirt so what we
have in our array here is not any kind
of direct reference to the object we
have on top here these are just copies
and notice what is happening we are
copying derived objects
in spots that are designed to store
direct shape objects and you might guess
what this is going to do this is going
to slice off
circle and oval information and only
shape information is going to be stored
in this array here so if we happen to
look through this array like we do here
and try to
call the draw method
this is not going to call the most
specific drill method for circle or oval
this is just going to call the shape
version of our draw method here this is
something i want you to see okay some of
you might say what if i take my
shape information in here and assign
that to a pointer and then go through
that pointer to call the draw method
well i hate to break it to you but the
moment your data is sliced off in a
situation like this you'll never get
that data back so even if you try and
take the object and sign that to a
pointer or a reference you're never
going to get polymorphic data again the
data has been lost permanently and you
never get that so even if you try to go
through a pointer or a reference to
manage your object that we have in this
array if we call the draw method we want
to get polymorphic behavior we will get
to the shape version of our draw method
called so the data has been sliced off
permanently if we store our derived
objects in an array like this or even if
we directly assign a derived object to a
base object this is going to slice off
the data and we will never get it back
anyway you should really know this okay
anytime i try to explain this
students mostly come up with this
question what if i try to store
references in my array
and do something like this now this is
not going to work and this is not even
go past the compilation stage of your
program the reason is we can't store
references in a collection and the
reason has to do with the left
assignability rule you can't assign to a
reference and i changed the reference to
store somewhere else and it really drive
this home let's look at this example
here we have a variable called a it is
of entertype and we have a 56 value
inside and we set up a reference which
is going to be referencing the data we
have in a and down on this line here we
try to change the data in our reference
but this is not going to be changing
where this reference is pointing to or
where this reference is referencing this
will merely be changing the values in
our reference here and once we have this
reference we'll never be able to change
where it is pointing again so from this
hopefully you can understand that
references are not left assignable you
can't store thanks that are not left
assignable in an array
because an array is designed to modify
the data of what is stored inside so if
we set up an array like this
the compiler thinks that at some later
point you will want to assign
other data to what is already stored in
this array and there is a hard
requirement on the data you store in
your collections for the type of that
data at least to be left assignable
and references are not left assignable
so we can't store them in a collection
like this if we're trying to do this
we're going to get a compiler error but
again some of you are going to say what
if we store in pointers well this is
going to work this is the basic working
principle of polymorphism
going through base pointers to manage
derived objects this is going to use
polymorphism and here we will get the
most basic draw method called
so if our object is a circle we will
call the draw method on the circle
object if it is a novel we're going to
call the draw method for the over part
of our object here this is even going to
work if we go through smart pointers so
if we do something like this and store
in smart pointers and create our smart
pointers on the fly in our initializer
here this is going to work because
really a smart pointer is a wrapper on
top of the regular roll pointer in c
plus plus so again the message here is
that you need to be careful on what you
store in your collections if it is a raw
piece of ghana your data is going to be
sliced off if you store derived objects
in a collection that is designed to
store
base class data if you store any
references that's not even going to
compile but if you're storing any kind
of pointer row or smart this is going to
work because polymorphism was designed
in the first place to work with base
pointers that are managing derived
objects this is really cool and i want
you to be aware of this now that you
know this we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with this a
little more here we are in our working
folder the current project is
polymorphic objects stored in
collections we are going to reuse the
code from the last lecture because we
need our inheritance hierarchy here and
this is going to serve us just well
we're going to copy this
and we are going to head over in our
current project and put in our code and
then we're going to open this in visual
studio code pretty quick let's do this
this is going to give us our code and we
have our shape class which is really
what we already know we have our oval
class
and we have our circle class take a good
look at this and what we want to see is
what happens
if we use different kinds of setups to
store objects of this inheritance
hierarchy in a collection like an array
let's go back to our main cpp file and
we are going to take out what we have in
here we're going to set up what we're
going to be using in this lecture we are
going to set up a bunch of objects that
we're going to be using here basically a
bunch of circles and ovals we can close
the left sidebar here and have some more
breathing room after this we're going to
set up an array which is going to store
copies of this object in this array here
which is called shapes one and after
this we're going to try and loop through
this array and try to do things with it
for example we can say for shape and we
may want to call the draw method on our
copy here so for example we can say s
and say draw going to see what happens
here and
let's say references because we don't
want copies in our
range based for loop here so this is
going to avoid copies we do in this loop
and we're going to be directly
referencing whatever we have in this
array here
now what do you expect to get we have
derived objects in this array
and with the setup we have here because
we are using virtual functions
one would expect to get
polymorphic behavior so here we would
expect to get the
joe versions in circle and oval to be
called but that's not what is going to
happen we're going to see that we're
going to be calling shape versions of
our draw methods let's try and build and
show you this we're going to world with
gcc our favorite compiler the build is
going to go through we can kill this and
bring up a powershell window to allow us
to run our program we're going to say
rooster here and you're going to see
that we are drawing circle one over one
circle two over two circle three oval
three but we are calling the shape
versions of our draw method
and the reason is we are slicing off
derived class information in our objects
the moment we try to make a copy and
copy in a spot that is designed to store
objects of the base class so this is
basically what we saw in the last
lecture
on the slicing but it is disguised
because we are storing data in an array
and when you store data in an array like
this you're going to be making copies
and storing copies in your array and in
any copy you make you're going to be
basically slicing off oval and circle
information and only storing in shape
information for our objects here this is
what the compiler is going to do and
that really try and prove this we can
try and print the size of these objects
and see the sizes of these objects in
this array here when we loop so for
example we can say stdc out size of
circle one do we have circle one yes we
do so we're going to say size of circle
one here
and we're going to put its size
information out here to be seen by
everybody we're going to say size of
circle one and we're going to print it
out and we are also going to print the
size of whatever iteration we are at in
our loop here that's the first thing
we're going to prep and we're going to
say size of object and we're going to
say size of s this is going to do
and we're going to loop and see if the
information we have on the outside is
the same as we have on the outside again
we are printing this information on the
direct object
which is really not yet in our array and
in fact we can
bring this in front of our array to make
this super clear and in our loop we are
printing information on a copy that we
have in our array because this is the
real deal we have in our array because
this is a reference hopefully this is
going to make sense and prove to you
that we are going to be working with
derived objects and the data is going to
be sliced off if we copy the data in our
array here this is what i want you to
see so we're going to run this again
we're going to pass this through gcc the
build is going to be good we're going to
clear
and run rooster
now let's look at what we have here size
of circle 1 is 56 but you're going to
see that the size for all our objects in
our array
has shrinked to 40 because derived class
information has been sliced off the
moment we copied our data in our array
here and this is what i want you to see
and i think we can even see this if we
go through our debugger for example we
can put a break point here
and uh open our run tab and if we try to
run our program through the debugger the
build is going to be good and the binary
is going to be passed into our debugger
and we're going to hit our break point
in a minute so let's wait for this and
we have hit our break point here but
what we can do now
is look at our local variables on the
left let's look at our array the array
is called ships
and if we go up we're going to see our
ships one array
and we're going to see that we have five
indexes here because we have six
elements inside
we can expand and see what we have at
index zero and you're going to see that
we just have description data because
this is a shape if we go back in our
class we're going to see that the only
thing we have in our shape class is
really a description member variable and
it is what we see in our array here just
description information because this is
a shaped object and we have lost or
derived class information and this is
really cool but if we go on top and for
example expand circle one we're going to
see that we have a novel part of us and
we have a ship part of us but these
events have been stripped off in our
array when we slice off the data from
derived objects to only store shape
information in our array here i hope
this makes sense now we're going to kill
our debugging session because we don't
need this anymore and we are going to
comment this out and see some other
things so we are going to
comment with our data here we're going
to say if you store row derived objects
in an array which was set up to store
base class object the data is going to
be sliced off this is something i want
you to know but some of you are going to
say
what if we store it in references okay
so let's try and do that we're going to
set up a piece of code like this and
we're going to set up an array called
shapes2 and this array is going to be
basically storing references to the
objects we have on top here and we're
going to see what happens you notice
that we have a squiggly line already and
this is saying this is not going to work
because references can't really be
stored in collections
again as we saw in the slides the reason
is because
references are not left assignable and
they can't be stored in a collection
like an array here the basic requirement
on the types that you can store in your
array is that they have to be left
assignable and our references are not
rest assignable so this is not going to
compile if we try to build our program
we're going to see that we're going to
get weird compiler errors
and the build is going to finish with
errors and if we go up we're going to
see that declaration of shapes to us
array of references and this is not
allowed you can't have an array of
references in c plus plus and this is
the reason why so we're going to get a
compiler error here okay so now you know
this but some of you are going to say
what if we go through pointers well
that's going to work because
polymorphism through virtual functions
was basically designed to work with base
pointers that are managing derived
objects and this is what we have here so
if we look we're going to be getting
polymorphic behavior and if we call our
draw method on our pointer here we're
going to get the most specific
joe method called and this is what we
want so we're going to try and weld this
again and show you that this is going to
work the build is going to be good we
can clear
and run rooster and we're going to see
that we are going to be looping around
and if we call the draw method we're
going to call the overdraw method circle
draw method overdraw method circle draw
method this is basically what we want
and we are going through base pointers
to really use polymorphism here this is
definitely going to work if you go
through smart pointers so let's comment
this out and set up another example to
really drive this home you can really
use any kind of smart pointer you can
use unique pointer or shared pointers so
here we will just be storing in shared
pointers because this is easier to
handle and we're going to head over to
the top and include the memory header if
you remember if you want to use smart
pointers in c plus plus you will have to
include the memory header which brings
in the data to set up smart pointers in
your surplus plus code
so this is going to look good now and if
we build we're going to get the most
specific version of our draw method
called through polymorphism that is
using virtual functions here so let's
build and show you that this is going to
work the book is going to be good we can
clear
and run rooster and we are going to get
our versions of draw called the version
for a circle and the version for oval
because we are using base pointers to
manage derived objects here and our
class inheritance hierarchy is using
virtual functions for the draw method
here so this is going to work this is
really all i wanted you to see in this
lecture you should be careful if you try
to store
derived objects in an array that was
designed to store base class data if you
are using raw data you're going to get
slicing
and you really need to be aware of this
because you want to have derived class
information if you try to store any
references this is not even going to
compile because references are not left
assignable but this is going to work if
you use role pointers or smart pointers
because polymorphism was basically
designed to work with base pointers or
references that are managing a derived
object which uses polymorphism we are
going to stop here in this lecture the
next one we're going to learn about the
override mechanism in c plus plus go
ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about the override specification
a kind of setup you can do to avoid
errors in your inheritance hierarchies
if you use virtual functions to set up
polymorphic behavior for your derived
objects and this is something that was
set up in ziplus plus to avoid easy to
make mistakes
for example if you have an inheritance
hierarchy like this you might be meaning
to set up a draw overrides for what we
have in the base class and an override
is really a must specific
method that you have in your derived
class to really hide what we had in the
base class for example the draw method
novel is going to be overriding or
hiding what we have in shape
and the draw method in circle is going
to be overriding or hiding what we have
in oval this is the idea here but as you
set up your overrides you might make
mistakes for example you may mean to say
draw and i use a w that is in uppercase
and that's going to be bad because what
you will be putting in oval is going to
be a completely separate method that is
different from what we have on the top
and this is going to be really bad
you're not going to get polymorphic
behavior for the draw method in oval
because we are simply not overriding the
jaw method from shape and this is going
to be bad so in ziploc plus we can avoid
these problems by explicitly specifying
that the draw method we have in alpha is
an override and we can add this
specification after our method header
and the c plus plus compiler is going to
enforce that we are actually overriding
a method that exists in our parents
class which happens to be shape here if
we have no method called draw in the
base class we're going to get a compiler
error because we want to be basically
overriding any method here this is going
to protect us from problems if we make
typos in setting up our polymorphic
methods here this is the main thing we
can achieve with the override
specification now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is override here
we're going to grab the code from the
last lecture because we are basically
going to be reusing the same code over
and over
building on top of that if we need to do
that so we're going to put in our code
and we are going to open this in visual
studio code by dragging and dropping
here this is going to give us our code
and we can really do whatever we want
with that i think we can leave in the
code that is using the base pointer to
manage our derived objects i think this
is going to serve us
well enough and we can take out
everything else because that's just
going to be confusion we don't need all
this here this is going to be serving us
well now we want to learn about the
override key world
and to learn about that we're going to
introduce a title on purpose here for
example suppose we want to set up a draw
override and we use
an uppercase letter here for the w key
world i don't think this is really easy
to spot once you've made this mistake
and you're not going to be getting any
compiler error because
this is something valid you can set up a
completely new method and call it joe
and this is going to work but this will
be very hard to spot in your program and
the compiler won't protect you as we
just said if we build our program you're
going to see that it is going to bulk
just fine so let's pass this through gcc
the voltage is going to be good but we
want to get to the behavior that we want
i think we can take out this sddc out
statement inside our for loop here and
we can weld again this is going to be
less confusing okay so the build is good
we can bring up our powershell window
and i'm going to run rooster and see
what happens you're going to see that
for a circle we're going to draw a
circle
but for oval
we're going to be drawing shape so what
is happening here we are overriding our
joe method in the overclass so we should
get polymorphic behavior because this is
a virtual function and it is called draw
exactly the same thing like we had in
the base class except we've made a
really simple typo here but it is really
hard to track and get hold of we have
named our method draw but the w is in
uppercase so this is a completely
different method than the draw method we
originally intended to override in our
base class and this is really hard to
follow and keep track of we can protect
ourselves by adding the override
specification so if we say override the
compiler is going to help out and make
sure that we are actually trying to
override the method that exists in the
shape class and if it doesn't exist
we're going to get a compiler error then
we're going to look at this and really
spot this mistake here this is what you
can achieve with the override keyword
and in fact i do recommend and advise
you to use this in your inheritance
hierarchy if you happen to be using
virtual functions because
this is going to save you a lot of time
if you make mistakes like this so we're
going to try and run this and show you
the compiler error we get so let's do
that we're going to pass this through
gcc the board is going to
fail as we see here and we're going to
get a compiler saying errol virtual void
overall joe cost marked override but
does not override this is super clear we
are saying we want to override here but
we're not overriding any method called
joe with an uppercase because we don't
have that in shape here this is the
message once we see the problem we can
correct it we're going to use in
lowercase letter for w and this is going
to work just fine now we're going to use
the same mechanism to protect ourselves
from ourselves in circle class so we're
going to override our draw method but
we're going to say that we want to
override explicitly and if we're both
now let's pass this through gcc this is
going to build successfully and if we
run our program we're going to get
polymorphic behavior let's do that you
see that circle draw overdraw circle
draw overdraw this is what we expect
this is really cool this is really all i
had to share in this lecture i hope you
found it interesting use the override
keyword in your inheritance hierarchy
because that's going to protect you from
easy to make typos that are really going
to give you a hard time otherwise we are
going to stop here in this lecture in
the next one we're going to explore the
concepts of overriding and hiding in
detail
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
zoom in on overloading overriding and
hiding we have seen that overriding is a
mechanism we have in c plus plus to be
able to set up
most specific versions of our virtual
methods in derived classes so for
example the draw method we have in oval
is overriding or eclipsing the one we
have in shape and the draw method in
circle is overriding
or hiding or eclipsing the one we have
in awful this is the concept here but
what happens if we introduce the concept
of overloading and mix that up with
overriding as we have seen so far so
suppose we do something like this this
is our shape class it is going to have
two versions of the draw method we have
one that takes one parameter for example
this could be the color that we want to
draw our shape with and another one is
not going to take any parameter and
these are two overloads of our virtual
method here so what is going to happen
in our derived classes that are going to
inherit this virtual method so let's
look at an example here we have a simple
example that is setting up objects of
our shapes we have a shape object we
have a novel object and we have a circle
object here if we call the draw method
on our most derived class which is
circle we're going to see that this is
going to work we can draw without a
parameter and we can draw with one
parameter which is going to be our color
depth this is going to work just fine we
will be reusing
our inherited method from the shape
class and this is really cool but what
happens if you override this method in
our overclass suppose we hijack the
inheritance process and set up another
draw method in our overclass and we only
override the overload that doesn't take
any parameter we can do something like
this but the moment you do this this is
going to only override this method and
it is going to hide all the other draw
methods that we had in our base class
which is shaped here and this is
something i want you to know so once you
override a single overload of your
virtual functions
all the other overloads are going to be
hidden and they won't be usable anymore
by downstream inheritance classes if you
want all the overloads to be available
to downstream inheritance
classes you have no choice but to
explicitly override each of them and
that's how it's going to work so if we
look at the example here we're going to
see that the draw call without a
parameter is going to work because this
is overridden in our oval class but if
we call the one which takes a parameter
this is going to be hidden at the oval
level and we want to have access to that
in circle and if we try to call this
we're going to get a compiler error
again the message is if you override one
overload of your virtual functions in
the base class all the other ones are
going to be hidden and you have no
choice but to explicitly override them
for them to be available and usable in
downstream classes this is the message i
wanted to convey here okay so now we
know this but what if we set up another
overload
downstream for example what if we go in
our oval class and set up another
overload which is going to have two
parameters for example we might have the
color depth and the color here that we
want to draw with okay so one thing you
should know is that this this method is
not going to participate in shape
polymorphism and what i mean is that if
we go through a base pointer or
reference to manage derived objects we
can't really call this method with shape
polymorphism so if we go through our
shape pointer or reference we want to be
really able to call this method if we
try to call it we will get a compiler
error the reason is this method is not
known
to the shape class that's why it's not
going to participate in shape
polymorphism the only methods that are
polymorphism are the methods that are
declared in the base class and they are
virtual this is the condition here and
if you violate this condition in any way
shape polymorphism or base class
polymorphism in this case is not going
to work and you will get a compiler
error so if you try to do something like
this and you want to call your draw
method with two parameters you're going
to get a bunch of compiler errors and
this is not going to work another thing
i want you to see is that if you assign
a derived object to a base object
your derived virtual functions are going
to be wiped out as part of the slicing
that we have learned about already so
the circle port is going to be wiped out
the oval part is going to be sliced off
and the draw method is going to go with
our oval part and we will only be left
with the shareport and if we try to call
this method here we will get a compiler
error because it's no longer available
it's been sliced off this is really what
i want you to see here now that we know
this we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with this a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is overloading
overriding and hiding we want to explore
these concepts in a little more detail
we're going to grab the code from the
last lecture because that's going to be
a good starting point we're going to
take out the binary we don't want that
and we're going to copy and we're going
to put that in our current project here
this is going to do and we are going to
open this in visual studio code pretty
quick by dragging and dropping here and
we're going to see that we have a bunch
of
virtual functions here who just have the
draw version but we can set up an
overload of this draw method here this
is what we want to do so i am going to
go below here and set up an overload of
this method this is going to be taking
the color depth as a parameter and we
want to see how usable this is
downstream so we're going to go down in
the main cpp function
and take out what we don't need here we
really need a bunch of objects we can
set up circle one and over one and we
will see that we can call this method
we're going to say circle one draw
without a parameter and we're going to
say circle one draw and pass and 44 as
our parameter and let's go back and make
sure that we have our overload and this
is going to be taking the color depth
and let's try and build our program
because we have a squiggly line here
let's see if it is just a visual studio
code playing games with us we're going
to pass this through gcc and we will
have a compiler error here so what is
going on candidate virtual draw cost
let's go up and see what kind of problem
we have here ah this is the concept we
just talked about in the slides we are
setting up our overloads here but this
is being eclipsed by the overloads that
we are setting up in oval you see we
have a draw override and this is also
being eclipsed by the override we have
in our circle class here if we want the
two overloads we have from shape to be
available we can comment out the
overrides we have both in circle and
oval let's do that and that's going to
be available and usable so let's do that
this is a really good learning
opportunity and now if we go in main cpp
we're going to see that this is going to
become available so we can upload this
with gcc again to bring visual studio
code up to date and you see the build is
good and our methods are usable even
from derived classes so for example we
can also set up a novel object let's say
oval one and say draw this is going to
work if we say ovo one draw and pass in
a parameter let's put in 54 for example
this is going to do you're going to see
that this is going to be accepted by
visual studio code and if we weld and
run this program it is going to build it
is going to be calling the inherited
functions in oval and
circle here the boat is good we can kill
our terminal here and bring up a
powershell window we can use to run our
program we're going to see that we call
shape draw and shape draw because these
are inherited functions from
the shape class that's why we are saying
shape draw here and we're going to be
drawing a oval and a drawing with a
color depth we're going to be drawing
the circle and drawing with the color
depth here this is the message i want to
convey but the moment we override these
methods in any downstream class for
example if we go in our over class and
and comment out the override for the
draw method notice that we are just
overriding a single overload again if we
go back to our shape class we have an
overload that doesn't take any parameter
we also have an overload which is going
to take one parameter in oval we are
just going to override the overload that
doesn't take any parameter but this is
going to hide all the other overloads we
had for the draw method here and this is
the only overload that is going to be
available
in downstream classes so if we go back
in main we're going to see that the one
with a parameter is not going to work
and we're going to get a bunch of
compiler errors this is going to be the
case even in circle if we
uncomment this guy the others are going
to be eclipsed again the other one we
have is just the one with one parameter
but this is going to stay true even if
you have a hundred overloads all the
others are not going to be available if
you happen to only override one of the
overloads in other words
the other overloads are going to be
hidden by this one overall ride that you
are putting in your inheritance
hierarchy you should really know this if
you want this guide to be available in
downstream classes for example you can
also override that in derived classes
this is an option we can go in oval and
put in another overload for this this is
going to bring this back in scope so we
can say overdraw here with the color
depth i don't think we copied the right
thing we can grab this and go in oval
and put this in place this is going to
do we're going to say oval drawing and
we can go in circle and also put this
end this is an option and we're going to
say circle drawing and now you see that
the squiggly lines in main go away
because we have overridden all the
overloads okay if we build and run our
program we're going to see that this is
going to work as we expect the world is
going to be good and we can clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
overdraw called overdraw called we are
calling our derived overrides and this
is really cool this is what we want here
let's take this back because we don't
want these
overridden in our inherited classes so
we're going to take this out in oval
and we're going to take this out in
circle and i want you to see that shaped
polymorphism is not going to work if you
override your methods at a downstream
level so what we are going to do we are
going to go at the oval level and set up
another overload for the joe method here
but this draw method is not going to
participate in shape polymorphism
because it is really declared at the
oval level and any base pointer we have
or any shape pointer we have is not
going to have any knowledge of this
overload that we are about to set up
here this is what i want you to know
okay so we are going to go in our oval
class and set up that overload we can
set that up here it is going to be taken
two parameters one is going to be the
color depth the other is going to be the
color and we don't want to pass a string
by a value like this we can use std
string view and we can include that if
we need to but it looks like visual
studio code has got this from something
else we have included before but we can
include that explicitly to avoid
problems so let's do that we're going to
say stream view here and now we want to
see that this method is not going to
participate in shape polymorphism even
if it is a virtual functions the reason
is this is not going to be known by your
shape pointers because it is not
declared at the sherpa level here i
really want you to know this we're going
to take out everything we had here and
we can set up a shape pointer we're
going to say shape and say ship ptr and
we're going to set up a derived object
here we can say new and serious circle
and what do we need to build the circle
object we need the radius and the
description so we're going to put that
in place here the radius is going to be
something like 10 why not and the
description is going to be circle one
how creative and we want to see if our
method is available through polymorphism
and it is not going to be available
because the method was not declared at
the shape level so if we do shape ptr
and say draw and we have a method which
is going to take two parameters at the
oval level we have the color depth and
the color
so for example if we go in main and say
the color depth is 45.21
not let's say this is something that
makes sense or let's use
45 because this is an integer parameter
and we're going to pass in a string
let's say red you're going to see that
this is not going to compile
because the draw method with two
parameters is not known at the shape
level this is the message i want to
convey here so if you want your method
to be usable with polymorphism the
method has to show up at the top level
this is what i want you to see here if
we're trying to build this we're going
to get a compiler error and you need to
be aware of this but know that even if
this is not working with shape
polymorphism this can work with oval
polymorphism and this is an idea i am
going to explore in the next lecture
where we learn about the fact that polar
morphism can be set up at different
levels so we are going to stop here in
this lecture and explore that idea in
detail in the next lecture so go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there in
this lecture we're going to explore the
idea that we can do
polymorphism at different levels in our
inheritance hierarchy
suppose we have a hierarchy like we see
here the top level class is animal and
we can derive from animal and create a
feline animal we can derive from feline
and create a dog animal we can derive
from feline create a cat animal we can
also do it the other way and create a
bird which is also an animal a bird is
going to have its own methods and member
variables that make it a bird we can
derive from a bird create a pigeon and
we can derive from a bird and create a
crowd
and we can do all these things that
these animals do
so the idea i want to expose here is
that polymorphism
doesn't have to always only work on the
top level class if you have an
inheritance hierarchy like this if you
want you can declare a virtual method at
the feline level and make sure that
method is also available in deriving
class and you can set up feline
polymorphism if that makes sense for
your application following the same idea
you can also set up a virtual method in
the bird class and you can have that
method overridden in downstream
inheritance classes like pigeon and crow
and you can set up bird polymorphism in
your c plus plus program if that makes
sense of course you can still use animal
polymorphism if you want to do that and
that's going to work as well this is the
idea we're going to explore here okay so
with that inheritance hierarchy in mind
we can create animal polymorphism and
animal polymorphism is just going
through the animal base pointer and
using that to manage derived objects for
example here we have a dog we have a cat
we have a pigeon we have a crow we can
do animal polymorphism and storing any
kind of animal we have here you see we
are putting in a dog we are putting in a
cat we are putting in a pigeon and we
are putting in a crow
and if we do animal polymorphism and
call the breathe method which exists in
any kind of animal we have in our
program this is going to call the most
specific breathe method on each animal
and this is going to work really well
this is going to do animal polymorphism
following the same idea we can also do
feline polymorphism and in this case
feline is going to be acting as our base
pointer so again we have our dog we have
our cat we have our pigeon if we do
feline polymorphism we will have to put
in all kinds of crazy felines we have in
our program for example we can put in
dog and cat and this is going to work if
you do fill out a polymorphism like we
are doing here and put in an animal this
is not going to work because the animal
top level class is probably not going to
override the
virtual method we are interested in here
for example here we are calling the run
method and the run method is not set up
at the animal level let's go back and
look at our inheritance hierarchy here
you see this is our animal class our
virtual method is going to be breathed
because any kind of animal we have is
going to need to breathe but the run
method is set up at the feline level so
if we try and store an an animal in a
setup that uses filing polymorphism the
run method is not going to be available
and we're going to get a compiler error
so i want you to know this but we will
also see this in a minute when we hit
visual studio code to really play with
us okay we can also do bird polymorphism
and here you see we have two objects one
is a pigeon the other is a crow
and we're going to do bird polymorphism
here and what that means is that we will
use a bird pointer to manage all kinds
of crazy birds in our c plus plus
program for example we can use that to
manage a pigeon we can use that to
manage a crow and if we loop through our
birds and call the fly method the most
specific fly method is going to be
called in this case at the first
iteration we're going to call the fly
method on our pigeon object at the
second iteration we're going to call the
fly method on our crawl object here and
this is going to work now that you know
this we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with this a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is polymorphism at
different levels we're going to grab our
template files let's grab it all we're
going to copy this and put this in our
current project
and we're going to open this little guy
in visual studio code like we always do
and before we open this up i am going to
put in the classes i have lying around
on my drive and these are going to be
the classes making up our inheritance
hierarchy here to make things go faster
if you want you can grab these classes
from the attached resource section on
this lecture you're going to find all
these files you can download them and
put them in your project and use that as
a starting point because you don't
really want to be creating all these
classes this is going to just waste your
time the basic idea i wanted to expose
here is doing polymorphism at different
levels so we're going to open this up in
visual studio code by dragging and
dropping here this is going to give us
our good starting point you see we have
a bunch of classes in here but all these
classes are really trying to set up the
inheritance hierarchy we have here the
top class is going to be the animal
class
we can derive from animal and create a
filler in a class
and we can derive from animal and also
create a bird class we can derive from
feline and create a dark we can derive
from feline and create a cat
and we can also derive from bird create
a pigeon we can also derive from bird
and create a crowd class and at each
level we're going to have a virtual
method that we set up
that other deriving classes can call
through polymorphism for example if we
do animal polymorphism we will get the
correct breathe method called regardless
of the actual object we are managing
with our animal pointer
if we do feline polymorphism we can
manage our objects through feline
pointers but we will get the correct run
method called regardless of which kind
of object we are calling this method on
so if we call the run method on a base
pointer managing a dog object we will
get the run method called on the dog
object this is what we mean here okay so
we have our classes here let's take a
closer look at our animal class it is
our top level class and it is going to
have a virtual method which is called
breathe it is caused because it is not
modifying our class here notice that we
don't have a virtual destructor because
i wanted to keep this simple but in your
practical object you should make your
destructors virtual if you happen to
have a virtual function in your class
here so for example we can even do that
let's make this virtual this is not
going to cost us anything
and
this is going to be our top class we
cannot look at the implementation file
it is not going to do anything special
it is just going to forward whatever
parameter we pass and use that to
initialize our member variable i think
we can also go in and change our
parameter to a string view so we can do
that hdd string view let's go in the cpp
file and also change that pretty quick
we're going to say std string view here
and this is our animal class we're going
to go in our feline class because that's
the deriving class
feline is going to be inheriting from
animal publicly just as we see here
we're not going to really do anything
special we're going to set up a member
variable called fur style
and we're going to forward the data from
our constructor and use that to
initialize stuff in our class here our
parameters are also going to be passed
as std string view types so let's do
that here and this is in place we also
have a virtual method which is called
run and inside we are just printing
which kind of object we have
and uh giving a hint on the method that
is being called here this is what we
just do here and we don't intend to
create feline objects directly that's
why we're not setting up any overrides
of the top that's why we are not setting
up any direct specific
overrides for these methods but we will
do that in downstream classes for
example dog and cat because that's going
to make sense there let's go in the cpp
file for feline and also change things a
little bit we're going to use std string
view parameters let's do that for the
second parameter as well and this is our
filling class so we can go in and look
at our dog class let's see if we can
find it and i don't think we made our
destructor in feline a virtual so let's
do that and look at our delta class
pretty quick here we have our dog it's
going to have no member variable at all
and it will just forward this data to
upstream classes but we can override our
breathe method we get from the animal
class we can do that and we are going to
say we can grab this entire thing and
we're going to go in dark we can do that
if we want we're going to put this
method down below here and we're going
to say breathe we're going to say that
this is overriding what we have on top
and we're going to say dog breathe
called this is going to do and we also
need to change our parameters to hdd
strength view let's do that this is
going to make things work better because
we will avoid unnecessary copies and we
will be able to pass string literals as
parameters to this constructor here this
is what we want to achieve with us we
can hit the cpp file for a dog class and
we're going to
change the parameters again std string
view and we're going to say std string
view as well here and we're going to go
to the header file again and make sure
we have a virtual destructor here
because this is good practice if you are
using virtual functions like we are
doing here we can grab our breathe
method and hop over to our cat class
again remember the inheritance hierarchy
we are going after is what we have here
so if you are confused please come back
and look at this you're going to really
understand what we are doing here we're
going to go to the dog class and make
sure it is working as we want so we just
did the dog class and we just made sure
it works like we want now we're going to
hop over to cat and make sure it is now
we're going to hop over to the cat class
and make sure it is overriding the brief
method to make sure the correct method
is called okay so let's do that we're
going to hop over to our cat class it is
going to
have its own meow method but it can also
override the breathe method we get from
the animal class so let's do that we can
grab this
and we can go to our cat class let's do
that we're going to put in our virtual
method and we're going to say cat
breathe and this is really all we also
need to set up our parameters correctly
using std string view let's do this std
string view and this is really all we
need to do here we can also make our
destructor virtual because this is good
practice we hop over in the cpp file and
change our parameters to be of type std
string view let's do this and this is
done we can really work with this
inheritance hierarchy here we're going
to also go pretty fast and work on the
other side of our inheritance hierarchy
we're going to work on birds let's look
at the bird class it is going to inherit
from animal it is not going to do
anything special really but we just want
to change the type of our parameters to
std string view and i'm going to do that
on the second parameter and we are going
to hop over in the cpp file and change
these things here let's do that we're
going to say std string view and do the
same thing here std string view and bird
is done we can grab our breathe method
for example let's go back to the top and
grab that from our animal class and
we're going to hop over to one kind of
bird we have in our program we can look
at
pigeon for example the last class here
we're going to override the breathe
method and i'm going to say pigeon
breathe and we are going to change the
type of our parameters here to std
string view and i'm going to do the same
here and let's hop over to the cpp file
and change the type of our parameter
let's do that for the second parameter
here this is done let's look at the
second kind of bird we have i think we
have the crow class we also want to
override the breathe method we're going
to say crow breathe and we can go up and
change our parameter to be of type std
string view and we're going to do that
here again if you are not interested in
these changes you can just grab the code
and you're going to have all these
classes ready for use i just wanted to
correct this little problem i had in my
classes on my drive because this is not
good to design in modern c plus plus we
wanted to do things proper because we
are really learning about modern c plus
plus here let's hop over to the cpp file
and finish this up we're going to change
the type to hdd stream view and uh let's
use view correctly and we're going to
say std string view on the second
parameter and this is done now we have
our inheritance hierarchy and we're
going to start by looking at animal
polymorphism again we just set up this
inheritance hierarchy now we are going
to try and do animal polymorphism okay
so now we're going to hop over to the
main cpp file and we are going to clean
it up a little bit remove whatever it is
we don't need we are going to put in our
includes we're going to include all of
the fans in our file here animal feline
dog cat bird pigeon and crow we're going
to include all this and we just want to
play with animal polymorphism here we
are going to set up a bunch of objects
and we're going to put in dog cat pigeon
and crow all kinds of crazy animals we
can create in our c plus plus program
and we're going to put them in an array
that is storing animal pointer and this
animal pointer is going to
enable polymorphism for our objects that
we have in here remember animal sets up
a virtual method called draw if we go
back we're going to find that and we
made sure to override this method in all
kinds of crazy animals we can create for
example in our cat we have a breathe
method overridden in our dog class we
have the breathe method overridden and
what we want to achieve in our main cpp
file let's go there if i can find it we
want to achieve a setup so that if we
call the breathe method we're going to
call the most specific breathe method on
our animal pointer here even if we are
calling that method on a base pointer
this is what we want to achieve this is
going to be animal polymorphism because
the base pointer is of animal type this
is what we mean here let's try and build
this program so if we look and call the
breathe method the correct breathe
method is going to be called and what we
expect for the first object which is a
dark object we're going to get the dark
breathe method called for the second
iteration the category breathe method is
going to be called for the third
for the third iteration the pigeon
breath method is going to be called for
the last iteration the
crow breathe method is going to be
called this is what we expect to see
if we run this program here so let's do
this we're going to pass this through
gcc our favorite compiler we can use any
compiler we want but gcc is going to do
in this case okay the build is good we
can bring up a powershell window to play
with and we're going to run rooster our
program and if we run this you're going
to see that in our loop the first
iteration is going to call dog breathe
because the first object is a dog the
second iteration is going to call cat
breathe because the second object is a
cat
the third iteration is going to call
pigeon breathe because the third object
is a pigeon and the last iteration is
going to call crow breathe because the
last object is a crow and notice that we
are calling the breathe method through a
base animal pointer and this is what
polymorphism is all about and what we
are doing here is animal polymorphism
but this is not what we are really after
in this lecture we want to see that we
can also do
feline and
bird polymorphism in our inheritance
hierarchy so we're going to put in a
separator let's do sddc out and put in a
bunch of dashes here or hyphens some
people call them like that doesn't
really matter and we're going to play
with feline polymorphism let's do this
we are going to go down and put in a
simple piece of coat that we're going to
be using to play with things here and
we're going to set up a bunch of objects
we have a dog we have a cat we have a
pigeon and we are going to use a feline
pointer to manage feline derived objects
for example we're going to use this
pointer to manage a dog and a cat but
one thing i want you to see is that if
you put in a pigeon for example this is
not going to work because a pigeon is
not a feline so the compiler is going to
give you a compiler error let's try and
do that we're going to try and put in
pigeon here pigeon 2 you can select this
and if we do that you're going to see
that we get a squeaky line this is the
sign that this is going to go wrong
because
we are storing in felines and the pigeon
is really not a feline even by our
inheritance hierarchy so the compiler is
going to give us a compiler error let's
try and weld to show you the compiler
error okay the world finished with
errors and if we go and we're going to
find that cannot convert pigeon to feed
line pointer so this is the error here
you can't do something like this even if
you create an animal object let's say
that we're going to go in and create
animal and we're going to say animal one
we can do that and we're going to pass
in the description i think we can do
that we can do something like this and
if we try and pass in the address of
animal one let's do that this is also
going to give us a compiler error
because animal is not a feline again if
you get confused come back and look at
our inheritance hierarchy here
what we are setting up in our code we
are using feline polymorphism but we
want to store an animal in a raid that
is storing felines and this is going to
be a problem because the compiler isn't
really going to be able to process this
our base pointer is a feline and we
should really be able to only store in
derived types from feline but we are
putting in a superclass or a parent
class of feline
which will not be able to have these
specializations that feline is doing so
the compiler is really saying this is
crazy i can't do this i am going to
throw a compiler error this is the
behavior we get here okay so this is
going to give us a compiler error and
let's run and see that we're going to
use gcc the book is going to finish with
an error and we are going to see that we
have an invalid conversion from animal
pointer to filament pointer this is what
we want to do here we want to convert an
animal pointer and store that in a slot
that is only supposed to store feline
pointers so this is not going to work
but if you do everything right and only
put in
derived types of feline you're going to
get the correct length to work and let's
look at our dog class let's open it
again we're going to look at dog and
we're going to have a run method but we
don't have that set up for our dog class
but we can do that pretty quick let's
look at cat and see if we have a run
method we don't but we can set that up
let's go to feline and copy our virtual
function we can do that
and we are going to go in dog
and set up another virtual method which
is going to be
run and this is going to be an override
of what we have in our inheritance
hierarchy so this is an override method
we are also going to do the same but
before we go let's say that this is the
dog class we are doing thanks from
we are going to grab this method again
and go in cat because that's another
feline we have in our program we can do
something like this and we're going to
say cat here
okay so now let's come back to maine
and we're going to weld again we're
going to pass this through gcc and we
still have a pigeon in here so this is
not good let's check this out
make sure that we only have a few lines
in this array here let's build again
okay you see the bolt is good
we can clear
and run rooster we're going to have our
separator here and you're going to see
that we are calling our dog method at
the first iteration because the first
object is a dog and we are calling a cat
running method because the second object
is a cat and this is filing polymorphism
in action hopefully this proves to you
that we can do polymorphism at different
levels depending on what we want to
achieve in our c plus plus program to
close off this lecture we are also going
to set up bird polymorphism let's do
that we're going to put in a separator
and we're going to say vertical demod
present and we are going to put in a
bunch of objects and set up a base
pointer
array which is going to be a bird
pointer array in this case and we're
going to be storing in derived objects
of the base pointer type so we are going
to be storing any derived objects of
bird and we have a pigeon and a crow and
this is the setup we want here now let's
go and look at the setup we have in our
pigeon for example we don't have a fly
method we just have a cool method
because the pigeon coos
if we go in our crow we're going to see
that we don't have
fly method we're just having the cow
method because the crowd calls
but if we call our fly method because we
don't have this method overridden in any
downstream classes of bird
we will get the
base
version of the fly method called so we
will get this method here
called i want you to see this let's hop
over to the main cpp file and make sure
we have the correct setup looks like
this is what we want we're going to
build this with gcc the book is going to
be good as we see here and we're going
to run now we're going to see bird fly
bird fly for pigeon one and crow one
but this is not using any derived method
that we have in our crow
and a pigeon class if you want you can
also override the
fly method and you're going to get that
called let's actually do that because
i'd like to show you things directly so
that you can really see with your own
eyes so we're going to go in bird and
grab the fly method and we're going to
override this in pigeon we can do that
and we're going to override here and we
are going to say pigeon here and we can
grab this and i put this method also in
the crowd class can do that and we're
going to say crow here now if we run
this program
using what we have in the main cpp file
for the first iteration we're going to
call the fly method on the pigeon object
because we have the fly method
overwritten at the pigeon level
as we see here this is right here
beneath our eyes and we're going to see
this in action if we run this program
here the same is going to happen for the
crow object here let's build with gcc to
really prove this the builder is going
to go through we can clear and run
rooster and we're going to see pigeon
fly crowd fly this is proving what we
set up in this lecture here this is
really all i had to share i hope you
found this interesting the main message
is that you can set up polymorphism at
different levels in your inheritance
hierarchy depending on what you want to
achieve in your c plus plus program we
saw that we could do the usual thing and
use the top level class
as the driver for our polymorphism and
we did animal polymorphism here but
nothing prevents you from doing feline
polymorphism or bird polymorphism as we
saw in this lecture we are going to stop
here in this one in the next one we're
going to see how we can do polymorphism
with static members
go ahead and finish up here and make me
there in this lecture we're going to
explore how inheritance and polymorphism
play out with static members that we
have in our classes and we're going to
be using this inheritance hierarchy here
our base class is going to be shape
we're going to inherit from that and
create an ellipse class let's look at
some code here so we're going to set up
our base class as shape as we said and
we're going to have one member variable
which is going to be our description
here we're going to have a constructor
and a destructor
and we're going to have a default
constructor which is really not
important here but notice that we have a
static member which is called m count
and if you remember a static member
variable
is a kind of variable which is
associated with the type itself it's not
associated with any object that you
create if you forgot this please go back
to our chapter on classes or user
defined types you're going to learn all
about static variables here we are just
exploring how they play out with
inheritance and polymorphism now we have
a shape class if we inherit from it and
create an ellipse class for example
we're going to have all the data that
was public in our base class to be
public in this class as well so by that
logic we are also going to get this
static variable inherited and we're
going to be able to access it from
ellipse objects let's try and use this
in code here to really drive the point
home here we are creating a batch of
shape objects here is our first shape we
print our static variable through this
syntax here because it is public we can
do this we're going to get a one because
we just have one shape here we create a
second shape and we print the count
we're going to get two because we just
have two shapes in here we create our
third shape and we try and print the
count we're going to get three and if
you wonder how we are incrementing this
static variable we may do this in our
constructor we're going to see how this
works exactly once we hit visual studio
code in a minute but note that every
time we create an object we're going to
be incrementing our static variable
that's why we see one two three as we
created these objects here this is the
logic now we have three shapes here we
go down and create a new object which is
of ellipse type if we print the shape
count we're going to get four because an
ellipse is a shape and ellipse is
inheriting the static variable from
shape so we're going to get a 4 printed
out here but if we also print ellipse
count we're going to get a 4
even if we really just have one ellipse
so the static variable from shape is
being inherited and used in our ellipse
class and this may not be
what we want so
the problem here is that the static
variable we are using in shape and
ellipse are the same because the one we
have in ellipse was inherited from shape
that's why we have these results here
but sometimes we just want to have
ellipse count to b1 here because in
reality we really have one ellipse so
how do we do that to get that behavior
you can also set up another static
variable named exactly the same way at
the ellipse level and you can do that
like this you can also override the gate
count method to return the current count
in ellipse this is going to work through
polymorphism because the getcount method
is a virtual function
if you call this method through a
basepointer you will get the correct one
called which is going to be the most
specific one through polymorphism but
what we want to see is how
things are going to work now that we
have a static variable which is named
exactly the same as the one we have in
our base class here the one in shape is
exactly named m count it is a static
variable of type and the one we have in
ellipse is also the same it is a static
variable called m count of type and but
now
ellipse is going to maintain its own
static variable and shape is going to
maintain its own static variable now we
are going to get this kind of behavior
we are going to see that if we try and
print the count of shapes we have we're
going to get a four here but now if we
try and print the count from ellipse
we're going to get a one because we
already have one ellipse and this is
working because ellipse is going to
maintain its own
static variable and this is going to
give you this behavior if it is what we
are after in our c plus plus program now
we can also go on and create a bunch of
other objects here we are going to store
them in this array which is going to be
storing shared pointers to shape
and we're going to store in derived
objects this is the syntax we can use to
do this and at the moment we do this
we're going to get six shapes because
in total we already have six shapes but
three of those shapes are going to be
ellipses and if we try to print the
ellipse count we're going to see that we
have three ellipses in our c plus plus
program and this is going to do
what we want another thing you could do
is also do shape polymorphism and call
the gatecount method and you're going to
get the correct getcount method and
print the most specific account if we
are calling that method on an ellipse
object for example we're going to print
three if we call that on a shape object
we're going to get sex and that's the
behavior we could achieve with
polymorphism with static member
variables and i really want you to be
aware of this now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is inheritance and
polymorphism with static members we're
going to grab our template files and put
them in place and i am going to grab our
classes from my drive and use this as
the starting point again if you don't
want to type or create these classes you
can use the files provided in the
resource section of this lecture you can
download them and use them directly
without having to create them because we
are really interested in how static
members behave with our inheritance
hierarchy which happens to be setting up
polymorphism this is what we want to
learn about here i am going to open this
up in visual studio code and we're going
to take a good look at our classes the
base class is going to be shape which is
what we have here it's going to have a
virtual method which is get count here
and we have a static member which is of
type and
i am going to change my parameter here
to bsdd string view
because that's what we should do in
modern c plus plus let's look at the cpp
file for this and we're going to fix
this a little bit and we're going to hop
over back to the header file and look at
what we have we have a virtual method
which is going to return this count here
it is a const method because it's really
not going to modify it's just going to
return a copy of the count member
variable we have here
and this is a static member variable
notice that it is not in line so we will
need to define this in the cpp file
somewhere because this is a declaration
we need to put in a definition which is
what we have in our cpp file here
because we are doing thanks in the older
c plus plus way we are going to
increment our account member variable in
our constructor and this is going to
achieve the behavior we really want to
have the m count member variable which
is static incremented each time we'll
create a shape object here let's go back
and look at our destructor and make sure
that it is virtual because we have
virtual functions in this class and this
is the setup we have let's look at
ellipse and we're going to take out this
static member variable because
we don't want to set it up as of now we
will enable it in a minute let's make
sure we remove this
and
let's remove this because i don't want
this and now we can try to create
objects of our classes and see how these
guys play out we can also go in ellipse
and make sure the constructor is taken
std string views where we are needing
strings you can do that and hop over to
the cpp file and do that std string view
i think this is going to make a visual
studio code happy by now
we can hop over to the main cpp file and
clean it up a little bit and we are
going to
include ellipse and in our main function
we're going to create a bunch of objects
let's close the left sidebar here
because we don't really need that
anymore we're going to grab a shape
object and we're going to print the
shape count we expect to get a one
because we just have one shape at this
moment we're going to create a second
shape here and if we print the count
we're going to get two because we have
two shapes this is what we expect we
create another shape which is going to
be shape three here we print the count
we're going to get a three but the
problem is going to come when we create
an ellipse here if we create an ellipse
and print the count we're going to get a
four because we have four shapes in our
c plus plus program but if we print the
ellipse count here we expect to get a
one but that's not what we're going to
get we're going to get a 4 because the m
count variable in ellipse is inherited
from our shape class so it is going to
be the same thing we have in shape here
because if you go back you're going to
see that at this point ellipse doesn't
have a static variable m count of its
own so it's going to use the one it is
inheritance from the shape class this is
the behavior we're going to get here and
i want you to be aware of this if this
is what you want this is fine but in
most cases you will want this to be
different because you want very clear
information about how many objects of
each type you have created in your
z-plus plus program if it is just shaped
this is going to be really vague because
you want to know if it is an ellipse if
it is a rectangle if it is a triangle
this is not going to be super clear so
let's weld and really show you the
problem here we're going to pass this
through gcc our favorite compiler we can
also bring up the left sidebar no
problem here and we're going to bring up
a terminal window or a powershell window
i can say
we're going to clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
the shape count is going to be one two
three
and we have a five here
because we are also incrementing the m
count variable in our derived class so
we are incrementing twice if we create
an ellipse object let's show you this in
ellipse cpp we are incrementing the m
count member variable but in the base
class we are also implementing that in
the cpp file that's what we have here
and notice that the derived class is
also calling the base class
through our initializer lust here so
this is the behavior we have we
shouldn't be incrementing this because
ellipse doesn't have its own static
variable as of now now we're going to
build and really solve this problem now
you see the kinds of problems you can
run into if you have a static variable
that is named exactly the same way and
you have an inheritance hierarchy
really weird problems can pop up and you
need to be aware of this let's build and
see that the problem actually
disappeared okay the bolt is good we can
clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
now this is what we expect one two three
because we have three shapes created up
to this point here if we create an
ellipse that's going to be another shape
if we get the shape count we're going to
get a 4 but ellipse count is also giving
us a 4 because ellipse doesn't have its
own static variable to solve this
problem we can go to ellipse and set up
our own member variable at the ellipse
level so we can enable this and
uncomment it we're going to go to the
cpp file and make sure we are
incrementing to get the correct count
incremented here i think this is all we
need to do we are also going to
initialize the static variable we have
at the ellipse level this is going to do
what we want and we can build again now
we're going to get the behavior we want
because at this point we are going to
print a one
for the ellipse count and this really
makes sense because we have one ellipse
even if we have four shapes in total so
this is the design i think
makes more sense in our c plus plus
program here we are going to build this
again and pass this through gcc the
builder is going to be good we can clear
and run rooster now we're going to see
that we have four shapes and one ellipse
this is what we want now that we have
this we can really do all kinds of crazy
things hopefully you can see that the
static variable is working exactly as we
want we can print the ellipse count we
can print the shape count if that's what
we want in our c plus plus program but
we can also do shape
polymorphism and get the correct get
count method called in our c plus first
program for example if we call the
getcount method on the basepointer that
is managing a shape we're going to get
this one called if we have a best
pointer that is managing an ellipse
we're going to get to this one called
this is going to be super cool let's go
up in our program and set this up we're
going to do this on the fly let's say
shape polymorphism and we're going to
say shift pointer and it is going to be
an array let's say shapes this is going
to do and it is going to be just an
array and we're going to initialize this
and store in a bunch of objects let's
put in a closing brace here let's go up
and see what we have for example we have
shape one and ellipse one we can use
these we're going to put in the address
of shape one and we're going to put in
the address of ellipse one this is going
to do
and we can loop through these guys and
call the get count method so let's do
this we're going to say for auto s
and let's do a reference because we
don't want copies and we're going to say
in shapes and we're going to call the
gatecount method we're going to say s
and say getcount this is going to
give us the count and we can print this
out if we want we can say sddc out and
count and we're going to
put a new line character here to
separate these guys
and we can
put a separator here we can copy what we
just used in our c plus plus program
here just to make sure this is super
clear when we print things on the
terminal here we're going to build our
program and see if it actually works the
body is going to be good we can clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
the count is going to be 4 for the first
iteration because we're going to be
calling the get count method from
shape because that's our base pointer so
this is what we're going to get we're
going to print the m count member
variable from the base class that's why
we have a four but on the second
iteration the object is ellipse and we
are using polymorphism because we are
going through a base pointer and this
base pointer happens to support the
virtual method get count we will get the
most specific one called on the current
object that our base pointer is managing
here and this happens to be an ellipse
so we're going to call the ellipse
version of our virtual function here and
we will get a one because we really have
one ellipse in our c plus plus program
this is what we see here this is really
all i wanted you to see in this lecture
how you can use
static member variables with inheritance
and polymorphism and you need to be
aware of these little things that can
really be confusing especially for
beginners we are going to stop here in
this lecture the next one we're going to
learn about the final specification we
can use in our inheritance hierarchy go
ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about the final specifier used in
inheritance hierarchies this is going to
allow you to do one of two things you
will either be able to restrict how you
override methods in the derived classes
or you can restrict how you can derive
from base classes i know this is in the
air but we're going to look at a few
examples to really drive this home
suppose we have an inheritance hierarchy
like we see here the top class is animal
we can derive from this and have feline
you can have bird as a derived class
feline can be inherited to have a dog
and cat and you can derive from cat for
example to have wild cat and bulldog
from dog you can do all these things
here and this is inheritance hierarchy
we're going to be using to learn about
these things now here is a possible
implementation for the dog class which
is going to be inherited from feline
publicly as we see here but take a look
at the run method we are setting up in
dag we are appending a final specifier
and what this is going to mean is that
no downstream inheritance class will be
able to override the random method
further this is what we can achieve so
if we don't want our derived classes to
override our
virtual method we can mark that method
as final in our class and we are
basically saying i am going to put in my
implementation but i don't want any
deriving downstream class to override
this method further if they do that they
are going to get a compiler error and
this is something we can achieve using
the final specifier in our inheritance
hierarchy again in this case we are
using this to restrict
how people can override our own virtual
method in downstream classes or i
shouldn't really say our own method
because it may be coming from upstream
but you are restricting people from
overriding that method further in
downstream classes here okay so this is
the first use we have for the final
specifier but we can also restrict
people from inheriting altogether so
here we have a simple example to drive
this home we have our cat class it is
going to be inheriting from feline but
we are marking our cat class as final
and what this is going to mean if
anybody tries to inherit or derive from
cat in any way they are going to get a
compiler error and this is what we can
achieve with the final specifier again
there are two things you can restrict
how people override your virtual methods
if you want to restrict that from the
current class you can mark your virtual
method as final you can also restrict
how people inherit all together from
your class and if you want that behavior
you can mark your class as final using
the syntax we just saw in the slides
here okay now that you know these things
let's look at a few things that may be
interesting for example here is a simple
fact that you can create a class right
away in market as final and when you do
this nobody will be able to ever inherit
from this class in your program and if
we do this we will get a compiler error
for example this is one thing i find
interesting and i really wanted you to
know this another thing is that it is
possible to introduce useless virtual
methods in your inheritance hierarchy
for example if our cat class is marked
as final what this means is that nobody
will ever be able to inherit from this
class but we are going further in
setting up a virtual method which is
meant to be inherited or overwritten in
downstream classes but how do we get a
downstream class if we can't inherit
from the cat class which is marked final
so so we have conflicting ideas here on
one hand we are saying we can never
inherit from this grant class but on the
other hand we are setting up a method
that is meant to be used or specialized
in derived classes so this is something
that is interesting this code is going
to compile and i think maybe in future
standards of c plus plus they are going
to fix this problem and maybe give you a
compiler error if you try to do
something like this but at this point
you're not going to get a compiler error
this is just going to be valid c plus
plus syntax even if this is really weird
we have conflicting ideas here okay one
thing you should know though is that we
can override in a final class and this
is going to make sense because for
example the run method is coming from
the feline class
and here we are just specializing that
so we are marking that as an override
here even if this is the final class so
be careful this is valid c plus plus
syntax this is going to work just fine
another thing you can do which is pretty
useless in your c plus plus program is
to introduce a virtual method and mark
it as final right away so again this is
really weird we have two ideas that are
conflicting the virtual keyword means
that we want this to be visualized in
the downstream classes but again we are
saying this method is final so no
downstream class will override this if
they try to do that they are going to
get a compiler error so this is again a
bunch of conflicting ideas c plus plus
is going to allow this syntax this is
not going to give you a compiler error
but this is weird and you need to be
aware of this okay now that you know
these ideas we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with the
final specifier in our inheritance
hierarchy we will be setting up this
kind of inheritance hierarchy and we
will set up a bunch of virtual methods
and mark them as final i think we will
do that in the dog class and we will
mark a bunch of classes as final and see
that if we inherit from them we're going
to get a bunch of compiler errors so
let's do this here we are in our working
folder the current project is final and
we are going to bring in our template
files pretty quick we're going to use
this as our starting point we're going
to put that in place
and i am going to put in a bunch of
classes i have lying around on my system
because i don't want to set up these
classes that would be a waste of your
time just know that we are trying to set
up this kind of inheritance hierarchy
animal is going to be our top dog or
animal is going to be our top class and
we will be inheriting from this creating
an inheritance hierarchy we can play
with in our code here okay so we are
going to open this up in visual studio
code so let's do that by dragging and
dropping here this is going to give us
all these crazy classes we have
the top class is going to be animal and
it is going to be defining the features
any kind of animal we support you know c
plus plus program is going to have for
example any kind of animal will need to
breathe and we will set up this virtual
method here
and we will be inheriting from this
animal class to create a feline class
and a bird class this is something we
did in a few previous lectures and we
are just reusing this inheritance
hierarchy here let's look at the feline
class the filament class is going to set
up a virtual method which is called run
and the method is going to be overridden
in the dog for example
we can override the run method but
notice that we are marking that as final
okay so look at this the method is final
and what this means is that
no downstream classes inheriting from
doug will ever be able to specialize or
override this method further if they try
to do that they will get a compiler
error notice that this may be our method
or it may be a method coming from
upstream classes in this case the run
method was introduced at the feline
level you see it was introduced here and
doug happens to be overriding this
method here that's why we have the
override key world but
at the same time we are going to mark it
as final
and prohibit or prevent
downstream classes from overriding this
method further if we look at our bulldog
class we're going to find the class to
inherit from dark we have our run method
here it is commented out at this moment
i just want you to see that our code is
just going to compile if we compile it
now
let's do this we're going to pass this
through gcc okay you see the bolt is
good and we have generated our binary
which is really not doing anything
because our main function is just some
dummy code we have here to make sure it
works with c plus plus 20 but what i
want you to see
is that if you go in bulldog let's go in
our bulldog class and uncomment
this class here or this virtual method
we're going to see that we're going to
get a compiler error we have a squiggly
line meaning that we did something wrong
and well let's look at the problems tab
from visual studio code here cannot
override find a function dog run this is
a final method from
the dog class if we try to override it
further we will get a compiler error
this is something we can achieve by
marking our virtual method as final as
we are doing here now if we try to build
this program we're going to get a
compiler error let's pass this through
gcc and let you see this okay you see we
get a compiler error and uh the error is
that we are overriding let's go up and
see the error here error and on line 12
in bulldog h we see that we are
overriding a final method virtual
void bulldog is a final function and we
are overriding this and this is going to
give us a compiler error this is the
behavior we get so the message here is
that you can go in your inheritance
hierarchy at any level and mark a
virtual method as final and prevent
download stream classes from
specializing or overriding that method
further and if they do that they will
get a compiler error this is something
we can achieve in our c plus plus
program another thing you can do with
the final specifier is that you can
prevent people from inheriting from your
class altogether let's go to our cat
class i think that's the example that
sets that up we have a cat class it is
going to be inheriting from feline but
the class is marked as final
now what this is going to do
it's going to throw a compiler error
anytime somebody tries to derive or
inherit from this class here so if
somebody tries to inherit from cat as we
are doing here create a wildcat from a
cat we are going to get a compiler error
because we can't inherit from cat
altogether it is a final class at this
moment okay so let's look at our wildcat
class it is going to try
and
derive from cat we can do something like
this we can remove our comments here and
if we try to do this we will get a
compiler arrow let's look at the cpp
file and see what we have it has nothing
special but if we try to do that and
inherit from cat we will get a compiler
error because the cat class is final and
you cannot derive from it if you do that
you will get a compiler error because
the cat class is final this is what i
want you to see here let's try and build
our program again we're going to pass
this through gcc and we will see our
compiler error okay the world is
finished with errors if we go up we will
see that we cannot derive from a final
base class if we do that we will get a
compiler error and this is what i want
you to see here okay now that we notice
we're going to take this back
and take out the compiler error here
because we want our code to compile
we're going to make sure it is compiling
fine okay now the code is compiling
because we are no longer trying to
inherit from cat and i want you to now
see a few interesting facts about the
final specifier when it works together
with virtual functions let's go to the
main cpp file and show you the first
fact and that's that you can create a
class right away and mark that as vinyl
as you create it as we do here if you do
that this class is going to not be
inheritable and if you try to inherit
from it you will get a compiler error
let's take out everything we have here
and just say hello in our main function
this is going to do just to have
something this is going to give us a
compiler error because we can't inherit
from a final class let's build and show
you the compiler error this is going to
go through gcc and the world is going to
finish with errors and that we have our
message here and we don't have the error
we expected because we forgot to put our
closing semicolon on our class
definition here but we can build again
and get our error okay the world is
finished with errors
and the error is going to be that we
cannot derive from a final class this is
what we expect here let's comment this
out because i just wanted you to see
this fact another interesting thing c
plus plus allows you to do
is to set up a new virtual method in a
final class let's first build and make
sure the compiler error here goes away
and i am going to show you that okay the
build is good let's go back in our final
class which is the cat class
if i remember correctly this is a final
class we can't derive from this class
but we can set up a virtual method for
example
the virtual method here called meow is
useless
why is it useless it is a virtual and
marking it virtual means that
you at least want people inheriting from
this class to inherit it and use it or
even better you want them to have the
ability to specialize
or override this method and make it to
do more specialized things but you can't
really do that because you can't derive
from this class all together so this is
something that c plus plus allows us to
do but this is a useless method which
will never be used in any way so this is
something i want you to be aware of but
this is going to compile again let's
pass this through gcc you're going to
see that this is going to compile and
work even if this method is really
useless i want you to be aware of this
okay so the build is good here okay so
this is our interesting fact number two
okay even if this method is useless
it is possible to specialize a method
coming from upstream classes from your
final class for example in feline we
have
a method called run which was introduced
there i think we can override this
method in our final class which is the
cat class here so this method is going
to be useless because it will be
specializing what we get from our
upstream class this is going to work
okay so since we are looking at a few
useless things you can do with final
combined with the
virtual mechanisms in c plus plus i want
you to see that it is possible to set up
a virtual method and mark it as a final
in the same declaration and we're going
to go to the bird class and really show
you that for example
we have a virtual method which is called
fly but this is marked final the moment
we declare it and this is going to be
contradicted for example the virtual
keyword means that people downstream
will be able to specialize this or
inherit this but at the same time we are
marking this guy as final so we are
saying nobody downstream will be able to
override this method if they do that
they will get a compiler error now which
one is going to win virtual or final
final is going to win because if you try
to override this method in downstream
classes you will get a compiler error
let's go down and look at one bird we
might have in our program for example we
might have a pigeon let's grab this
method and try to override it you're
going to see that we get a compiler
error we're going to go in pidgin and
put in the fly method and uh for example
we're going to say pigeon fly here and
we're going to say override we are
trying to override this method but we're
going to get a compiler error you see we
have a squiggly line because this is a
final method and we are trying to
override this in a downstream class
and this class is a downstream class
from bird and in bird we map this method
as final so this is not going to work
even if this is virtual you want to be
able to really use the virtual mechanism
because this is final if we try to
inherit from this if we try to override
this like we are doing in pigeon here we
will get the compiler error let's try
and build our program and we will see
that we get our trusty compiler error
the bullet is going to finish with
errors and if we go up we're going to
find our error we're going to say
virtual function fly overriding final
function we are overriding a final
virtual method and this is going to give
us a compiler error we can't do this
this is something you can do in your c
plus plus program so this is really
confusing because in bird the virtual
keyword suggests that you can really
specialize this in downstream class but
this is contradictant and c plus plus
allows you to do this you need to be
aware of this again if we don't override
this and leave this in the code is going
to compile but in my opinion this is
really confusing and you need to be
aware of this that's the whole point of
this lecture here let's make sure the
code is building and this is really all
i had to share in this lecture
introducing the final keyword to you you
can use it to restrict how people
override your virtual function or you
can use it to restrict
people from inheriting from your class
altogether and use these things if they
make sense for whatever application you
are designing with c plus plus we are
going to stop here in this lecture and
the next one i am going to show you a
secret you probably didn't know so go
ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
explore how virtual functions or
polymorphism plays with default
arguments and when we say default
arguments we mean a setup like this we
have a virtual function here which is
called add it is going to return double
and it has
default parameters here for a and b and
the value is five here in our derived
class we also have the same function we
are overriding that and we have a
different set of values acting as our
default parameter here we are using 10
for a and b here and we want to see how
this plays with polymorphism now please
note that with polymorphism if we go
through a base pointer to manage a
derived class object what we want is to
call the most specific implementation of
the virtual function here for example if
we have a base pointer managing a
derived object and we call the add
method from a base pointer we will get
the most specific method here called
but what you get with these default
arguments is that the compiler is going
to use static binding to decide which
default parameters to pass to your
function so even if you will get this
method here called the compiler will
still use the default arguments we have
in our base class so we will call this
method here but we will use the default
arguments coming from the base class and
this is the behavior you need to be
aware of okay so another way to put this
is that default arguments are handled at
compile time the compiler is going to
wire these things at compile time where
you are building your application
and the virtual functions are called at
run time with polymorphism so if you use
default arguments with virtual functions
you might get weird results with
polymorphism because the default
arguments you will be using are going to
be decided by static binding but the
actual function that you get called is
going to be decided by dynamic binding
so we will call the virtual function in
our derived class but we will be using
the default arguments from the base
class this is the behavior we'll get you
need to be aware of this and make sure
this is what you desire my personal
preference is to not use default
parameters or default arguments with
virtual functions because this is really
going to make my code hard to follow and
hard to understand especially for other
developers that might have to work on my
code base in the future okay here is a
simple example we have a base pointer
which is going to be managing a derived
object and we will call the add function
here what do we expect to get well
because we have polymorphism here we
will call the most specific add function
here and that's going to be the add
function from our derived class
but the default argument we pass are not
going to be decided by the derived class
the default arguments are going to be
plugged in at compile time using static
binding so because the base pointer is a
base object we will be using the default
arguments from the base implementation
of the add method so we will just plug
in five and five so we will add five to
five and add a two that's why we get a
12 right here
and if we go through these references we
will get the same result because this is
going to enable or trigger polymorphic
behavior in our c-plus programs if we go
through direct objects we will be doing
static binding and we will use the
default arguments or device parameters
from our derived object and remember
that we use the value of 10 in there so
we are going to add 10 to 10 and add a 2
and we are going to get a 22 as you see
here through static binding if we do
slicing by assigning a derived object to
a base object the derived information is
going to be sliced off and if we add we
will use the default parameters from the
base class and we will use the
implementation in the base class so if
we come back to our code here we will
use the default arguments from the base
class and that's a five and a five we're
going to add them up because the body is
going to be from the base class remember
the derived information has been
completely sliced off so we are going to
add a five and a five and a one and
we're going to get 11 printed out if we
do slicing and that's the result we get
right here as a closing note before we
head over to visual studio code again
default arguments with virtual functions
can be very confusing they are best
avoided because they really are going to
give a hard time to anybody that is
going to be working on your code in the
future now that you know this we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and play with this a little more here we
are in our working folder the current
project is virtual functions with
default arguments we're going to grab
the code from our template project we're
going to copy this and put this in the
current project and i am going to grab
my classes base and derived that we are
going to be using here if you don't want
to type along you can grab the source
code from the resource section of the
course
if you don't want to type all these
classes or create them you can grab the
source code from the resource section on
this lecture you're going to download
this and use this you don't have to
waste time typing these things because
many of these things are already
familiar to you we're going to open this
in visual studio code and we're going to
have our classes here we have a base
class which is going to have a virtual
function
with
a pair of default arguments here we are
using 5 5 in our ad
virtual function here
and if we go and derived it is going to
derive publicly from base and it is
going to override our
virtual function here but notice that it
is going to set up its own
default parameters so if we do
polymorphism
and use the base pointer to call the add
method here we will get the most
specific or the most specialized version
of the add method called and this is
going to call this body here
but the parameters are going to be
decided by static binding so because we
will be going through a base pointer we
will use the default arguments from the
base class that's going to be five five
and we're going to play with this and
see what this is going to give us in the
main cpp file here let's clean up a
little bit we're going to remove
whatever we don't need here
and we are going to include our derived
class we can do that we are going to put
in our code to really play with us let's
remove these spaces because we don't
need them we are going to go through a
base pointer to manage a derived object
and this is a setup we can use to put
things in place here we are going to
call the add method notice that we are
not passing in any parameter because we
are going through a base pointer and the
add method is virtual
polymorphism will kick in and we will
get the derived version
of our add function code so we will call
this add function here but
be careful because we want to be using
these default parameters here if we did
we would add a 10 to a 10 and get to 22
in our main function here but that's not
going to be the case the compiler is
going to use static binding to decide
which default parameters to use either
those in the base class or those in the
derived class and notice that if we
hover over this add function you see
that the compiler has plugged down those
from the base class and that's what the
compiler is going to do so it is going
to add a five to a five and it is going
to add two to that i think that's what
we are doing in our derived version and
we are going to get to 12 printed out
let's build and see if this is actually
the case we're going to pass this
through gcc
and that's the compiler that is our
favorite now the book is going to be
good we can close this and bring up a
powershell window and if we run rooster
we're going to see that the arrived ad
was called and the result was 12 here
this is what we get again
the compiler is going to call the most
specialized virtual function override
here but it is going to use the default
parameters from the base class you
should really note this and this can
really be confusing especially if you
are a beginner to polymorphism if we go
through a base reference we will also
get polymorphic behavior
so if we have a derived object and we
set up a reference to that which is of
type base and we go through that base
reference and called the add method we
will get the most specialized add
version called so that's going to be
derived and but we will use the default
parameters from the base class because
which default arguments we use is
decided by using static binding that's
what we get here and official studio
code is really helpful here because if
we hover over the add function we're
going to see which default parameters
were plugged in by the compiler and you
see that they are those from the base
class so we are again going to add five
to a five and we are going to add a two
and we will get 12 printed out here if
we boil and run we're going to see that
this is the case the build is good we
can clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
with a base reference we're also going
to get a 12. we will get the most
specific
implementation of the add method called
but we will plug in the default
parameters from the base class i really
wanted this to be super clear if you set
up things in a way that you are going to
get static binding then if you are going
through a base object you will call the
base version of the add method and you
will use the default parameters from the
base class if you happen to be
manipulating a derived object you will
use the information in the derived class
the derived version of the add method is
going to be called and we are going to
use the default argument from the
derived class so if we set up another
example here we can set up a base object
for example we're going to say base and
say base
3 we can do that and we try to call the
add method we can say base 3 and say add
we can try and store this in our
research variable and we can print this
out we're going to say sdbcl row
research we can say something like this
and we're going to print out the result
here if we build and run we're going to
see that this is going to call
the base version of the add method and
it is going to use the default
parameters from the base if we go back
to base we're going to see that we are
going to add a 5 to a 5 and we will get
11 because we will plug in a 1 and
return the result here let's build and
run and see that this is actually the
case so this is going to be completely
doing static binding let's clear and run
you see that the world is good we're
going to run restaurant and we will get
11 printed out here hopefully you can
see this if you assign a derived object
to
a base object you will get slicing
let's see that we can actually do this
but before we do that i also want you to
see that you can also do
row direct objects of derived classes if
you do this you will
get the information from the derived
class we will use the body from the
derived class and we will use the
default parameters from the derived
class so we will take 10 and add a 10
and we will add the 2 to that and we
will get a 22 printed out i think we can
do this
so
let's put in a separator because that's
going to make it easier to follow these
lengths and we're going to build with
the gcc the both is going to be good
hopefully
the bulk is good we can clear
and run rooster and we're going to see
that we get a 22 here if we assign a
derived object to a base object directly
by doing something like this event we
don't need this guy here
we can remove this we have a base object
that we are setting up here and we are
assigning a derived object to this base
object here
if we call the add method we will get
the version from the base class because
mind your steps this is going to slice
off all the derived information because
we are not going through any kind of
base or reference so this is going to
slice off all the information we have in
the derived
object here and we will be left with the
base information and if we call the add
function here you see that we are using
the default parameters from the base
class and we will use the body of the
base class implementation here so we
will add a 5 to a 5 and we will add 1 to
that and we will get 11 printed out as
we see here let's build and actually
prove this we're going to pass this
through gcc the world is going to be
good we can clear and run rooster and we
are going to see that the result is
irreverent if we do row object
assignment here this is really all i
wanted you to see in this lecture that
you should really be careful if you are
using virtual functions
mixed up with default arguments the
compiler is not going to do dynamic
binding on the default parameters it is
going to decide which default parameters
to plug in at compile time using static
binding so the compiler is basically
going to look at the type of the pointer
or object that you have and it is going
to use that to decide which default
parameters to plug in so at this example
here for example at line 7 it is going
to see what kind of pointer do i have i
have a base pointer so i am going to use
the default parameters from the base
implementation and if you hover over
here you're going to see that it is
going to plug in a 5 and a 5. even if we
are using the most specialized add
version in our inheritance hierarchy the
compiler is going to still use the
default argument from the base
implementation down here on line 16 the
compiler is going to say which kind of
reference do i have it's going to say
base because that's what we have here so
it is going to use the default
parameters from base and that's what it
is going to plug in here 5 and 5 and
we're going to get this result here
down here on line 25 the compiler is
going to see which kind of object do i
have here this three is a base so i am
going to use the default parameters from
base
down below on line 31 the compiler is
going to look and see
which kind of object do i have here the
object is derived so i will plug in the
default parameters for it derived again
this is really what the compiler is
going to do with default parameters the
compiler is never going to do dynamic
binding and this is going to make your
code really confusing again my advice is
to avoid default arguments or devote
parameters if you are using polymorphism
in your inheritance hierarchy we are
going to stop here in this lecture and
the next one we're going to learn about
virtual destructors
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we are going to
explore virtual destructors and these
are destructor methods you might want to
be called
using dynamic binding or polymorphic
behavior
we are going to be using this
inheritance hierarchy to play with
thanks so the animal class is going to
be our base class we are going to derive
from that publicly and have a feline
class and we are going to derive from
feline and have a dog class this is the
setup we are going to be using here
now let's look at some code we are going
to set up our animal class like there's
nothing really special here notice that
the destructor is a regular destructor
we have
we will derive from animal and create a
feline class which is going to set up
its own virtual function which is going
to be run if you want you can override
the breathe method but we don't want to
do that here because we just want to
focus
on the destructors here and the order in
which they are going to be called we are
going to derive from feline and set up a
dog class and this dog class is going to
set up its own virtual function and
notice that it has a destructor which is
really a regular destructor now once we
have this inheritance hierarchy set up
we might want to do something like this
we can create a dark object
and when it is time for this object to
be destroyed i want you to focus on the
order in which the destructors are going
to be called we have seen this before
the destructors are going to be called
from the specialized to the most base
implementation of the destructor so the
destructor for doug will be called first
then we will call the destructor for
feline then we will call the destructor
for animal now a problem is going to pop
up if we are using a base pointer to
manage a derived object with polymorphic
behavior that we might want for our
inheritance hierarchy here so we are
going to use an animal pointer to manage
a dark object like this and when it is
time to release the memory for this
object
we may be tempted to call the delete
operator on our animal pointer here but
this is only going to call the
destructor
for the base class and hopefully you can
see the problem here because our
destructors are not virtual the compiler
is going to use static binding to decide
which destructor to call so it is going
to look at the type of a pointer it is
going to see that it is an animal
pointer and it is going to decide to
call the destructor for animal here
that's why we get this reserve we are
managing an object which is not just an
animal it has derived information in it
but we are only calling the destructor
for the base part of this stun so any
piece of dynamic memory we might have
allocated in the constructors for feline
or dog is going to be leaked out because
remember even if this is a dark object
it is made up of base parts the
foundation for this is going to be
animal and on top of that we are going
to build a feline level and on top of
that we are going to build a dog level
in this case only the destructor for dog
is going to be called and any dynamic
memory that might have been allocated at
the feline and dog level is going to be
leaked out and this is something we
don't want you really need to keep your
eye out on this and this is something
really bad you really need to keep your
eye out for this so this is really a big
problem and to solve it we need the
destructors to be called using
polymorphism and you can set that up by
marking your destructors as a virtual if
you do this the compiler will know
that if you are going through a base
pointer to manage a derived object when
the time comes for the memory to be
released and you release the memory
through a base pointer the compiler is
going to call the most specific
destructor it can find and this is going
to solve our problem then we will reuse
the order we are familiar with the most
derived destructor will be called and it
will call its best destructor and that's
going to happen until we hit the most
base class in our inheritance hierarchy
and the memory is going to be released
exactly as we would want now that you
know this we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with us a
little more here we are in our working
folder we are going to learn about
virtual destructors and before we do
that we're going to grab our template
files and put them in place let's do
that and i am going to put in the
classes that make up our inheritance
hierarchy our most based class is going
to be base our most based class is going
to be animal after that we're going to
derive we are going to derive from that
and create the feline class and we are
going to derive from feline and create a
dog class here this is the inheritance
hierarchy we talked about in our slides
okay we are going to open this up in
visual studio code and this is going to
give us our classes here and we are
going to remove these virtual keywords
because we want to see
what would happen if you don't mark your
destructors as a virtual we're going to
do that for feline we're going to do
that for doug let's remove the virtual
keyword here we're going to remove that
and we're going to remove that for the
animal class and we want to see the
implementations for our destructors for
animal we are just going to say that the
destructor for animal was called for
feline we're going to say the same thing
feline destructor called for doubt we're
going to say the same thing we're going
to say destructor for dog called here
we are using strengths as our parameters
here so i think it is a good idea to
change these guys to use string view i
am going to do that
and come back when this is done
okay this is done all our parameters are
of std string view type and now that we
have this inheritance hierarchy let's
make sure none of the destructors is
virtual this is the case here we can
head over to the main cpp file and use
this inheritance hierarchy here we're
going to crack it open and remove
whatever we don't need here
we are going to include our dog class
which is going to implicitly include or
its parent classes so we're going to
include dog.h here and we are going to
create a row.object by default here
we're going to say dog and let's say dog
one we can do that and we might not even
give it any parameter this is going to
call the default constructor and if we
go to doug we're going to see that it is
possible to specify information here
first style description but we're going
to ignore this and we just want to see
which order in which the destructors are
called let's build and run this program
we're going to pass this through gcc the
book is going to be good if we clear
let's bring up a powershell window to do
that we're going to clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
dog destructor was called feline
destructor was called animal destructor
was called and this is really cool this
is the order we expect by default but if
we don't do something like this and say
animal pointer and say p animal to mean
a pointer to animal and we say new dog
we're going to allocate a dog on the
heap and we're going to manage that
using a base pointer and if we try to
release the memory here let's do that
we're going to say delete p animal let's
see which destructor gets called here
because notice we are using a base
pointer to manage a must specific object
here which is a derived class of dog
indirectly and we will see that we don't
get the destructors called in the order
that we expect let's build and run this
program to really see this we're going
to use gcc to build it
the world is going to be good as you see
here we're going to clear
and run rooster now you see that only
the destructor for animal is called even
if we are really managing a dog object
for things to work really well we would
expect the destructor for duck to be
called and then the destructor for a
feline and then the destructor for
animal to release or the memory that
might have been allocated by these
parent classes for our dog class if you
go back in the cpp file for example for
each of these classes you're going to
see that the compiler is going to be
calling
each base class of the current level
that we are at in doug cpp we are going
to call the constructor for feline the
constructor for feline is going to be
called if it is doing any dynamic memory
allocation we need to release this
memory constructor for feline is also
going to call the constructor for animal
and if animal is doing any dynamic
memory allocation this is going to need
to be called but notice that we are just
colon the destructor for animal and if
we only call this destructor all of the
memory that was allocated by the filing
constructor is going to be leaked out
because only the animal destructor is
going to be called hopefully you can see
the problem here but this is not the
only problem the c plus plus standard
says that if you do something like we
are doing here and call a destructor
using a pointer to the base class but
that pointer happens to be managing a
derived object this is going to give you
undefined behavior so you're not
guaranteed to get to the same behavior
on different compilers on different
operating systems so this is something
really bad we want all the destructors
in our inheritance hierarchy to be
called to properly release the memory
that would potentially be dynamically
allocated by each level in our
constructor calls the fix for this is
really simple all you have to do is mark
your destructors as virtual and the
compiler will call the most specific
destructor
for your classes so all we need to do is
go in and mark these guys as virtual so
we're going to do that the base class
destructor is going to be marked as
virtual we're going to go to feline and
do the same thing we're going to mark
that as virtual and we're going to go to
dog
and mark its destructor as virtual we're
going to do something like this and now
notice we don't need to change any other
thing if we build our program we're
going to pass it through gcc it is going
to do exactly what we want because
now the compiler will resolve the calls
to the destructors polymorphically
because we are going through a base
pointer the compiler will call the most
specific implementation for this
structure because we are going through a
base pointer to call the destructor here
the compiler will call
the most specialized destructor we can
find and it is going to find the
destructor for duck which is going to be
the most specialized destructor we can
find in our inheritance hierarchy it is
going to call the dog destructor that's
going to go the destructor for feline in
turn and then that's going to call the
destructor for animal and our memory is
going to be released properly that's
what we're going to see here let's make
sure we weld this again because i'm not
sure if i actually built this the body
is going to be good anyway so we're
going to clear and run rooster now you
see that the duct destructor is called
the vlan destructor is called the animal
destructor is gold and everything is
just going to fall in place so my advice
if you are using virtual functions in
your inheritance hierarchy make sure you
also mark your destructors as virtual
this is going to save you future
headaches you might come in contact with
if you are using a base pointer to
manage a derived object and you are
doing some kind of dynamic memory
allocations in your constructors that's
going to release the memory properly if
you are releasing the memory through a
base pointer like we are doing on line 8
here this is really all i had to share
in this lecture i hope you found it
interesting we are going to stop here in
this one in the next one we're going to
learn about dynamic casts
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture we're going to
learn about dynamic casts and the
dynamic casts are a facility we have in
c plus plus
to do downstream transformations
between our polymorphic types
so if we have a base planer for example
we can transform it to a derived type
and be able to use it like we use any
row object for example if we do this
kind of transformation we will be able
to call non-polymorphic functions and
this may come in handy sometimes
this is the hierarchy we will be using
our top class will be animal here we
will derive from this and create our
feline class and we will be live from
feline and create our dog class here if
we have a base pointer pointing to a
dark object for example the most
specialized class we can have in our
inheritance hierarchy sometimes we might
want to transform from this base pointer
to the most derived object here and get
to the direct most derived object that
we can really call anything on if you
remember with a base planer like animal
here the only thing we can do is really
call
polymorphic or virtual functions but
sometimes we want to do much more than
this for example if we want to call
non-polymorphic functions this is not
going to work because the best pointer
has no knowledge of those functions so
if we need to do that explicitly
transforming from a base pointer to a
derived pointer is going to give us that
capability if the actual object we are
pointing at happens to have that method
okay so this is what we are after in
this lecture we want to be able to
transform from a base class pointer
or reference to a derived class pointer
or reference at runtime another way you
can text this is to think of the base
class pointer or reference as input and
we want to get a derived class pointer
or reference as output in our c plus
plus program and the main benefit of
this is to be able to call
non-polymorphic methods on derived
pointers or references this is going to
be super cool in some cases okay so
let's look at our inheritance hierarchy
here the top class is going to be animal
as you see here it's going to have a
single virtual method it's going to also
have a virtual disruptor because we know
how to do this now we can derive from
this and create our filling class which
is going to be
inheriting publicly it's going to have
its own run method and it's going to
declare its own other method which is
not virtual we can also derive from
feline and create a dog class this is
how we do this and we're going to set up
our own virtual method in dog which is
going to be bark and we can really do
anything we want with this inheritance
hierarchy okay what we're going to be
using as input is a base class pointer
or a base class reference and we set
them up here this is our base pointer
this is our base reference and we want
to go from these and create a derived
class pointer or reference that we can
use to even call
non-polymorphic functions and we can
achieve that using dynamic casts here
we're going to show you how you can cast
pointers again our animal base pointer
is going to act as our input and the
output is going to be what we want to
get out of this transformation
and all we do is say dynamic cast we
specify a pair of angle brackets inside
we're going to specify the output we
want to get and this is usually going to
be a derived class pointer so the base
class pointer is going to be within this
parenthesis and and it's going to be our
output and this is going to do the
transformation and it's going to give us
a result that we're going to be storing
in our feline pointer here and if this
succeeds we will have a valid feline
pointer here and we can use it to call
non-polymorphic or non-virtual functions
like we are doing here and this is super
cool another thing you can do with this
is use the result of this transformation
in a pointer check for example we can
check and see if this pointer is not a
null pointer if it's not a null pointer
we can call our non-polymorphic function
to it the result was successful but if
it's no pointer we're going to fail and
fall down here and we can say that we
couldn't cast to a feeling pointer and
some of you might ask
how can this transformation fail well if
we go back to our code here we have an
animal base pointer which is really
pointing to a feline object in memory
if we try and cast this animal pointer
to dog
suppose we want to do this kind of
transformation try to think about this
this is not going to work because we
really have no dog information in this
villain object and if we try to cast
this to dog the compiler will really
have no way to do this and the
transformation through dynamic cast will
fail and we will say the message here
meaning that we couldn't do the
transformation the user asked for so
here we can do the transformation and
transform from a base pointer to a
derived pointer but we can also
transform to a derived reference and i
am going to show you the syntax to do
that and it is super simple we say
dynamic cast and we specify our input
reference
notice that this is a reference you have
to put it it's not a pointer and you
specify the output within this angle
brackets here once you do this the
output of this is going to be a derived
reference and we're going to store this
in our feline reference here once we do
this transformation and the
transformation is successful we're going
to be able to call our non-polymorphic
function this is going to work but with
references we don't have the luxury to
do something like a pointer check
because there is no such thing as a null
reference a reference is always pointing
to something
and if the transformation fails we will
have some kind of invalid reference and
if this fails it is probably going to
blow up and give us undefined behavior
so you don't really want to do this i
usually don't recommend
doing this kind of transformation with
references unless you know
that the transformation is possible
beforehand what i usually recommend is
to
pass through pointers and it is even
possible to transform a base reference
into a derived pointer and the syntax to
do that is what you see here okay and uh
once we do a transformation to a pointer
if the transformation is successful
we're going to have a valid pointer in
here if the transformation fails we're
going to have a null pointer and the
check is going to draw us here and we're
going to print this message to say that
we can't do the transformation here okay
again the cast may fail if it fails
while we are trying to transform it to a
dog pointer we are going to fall down
here and say that the cast failed we can
also do the same thing through
references for example if we want to
transform this base reference to a
derived pointer
and this fails we're going to follow
here because of the check we are doing
here we can do something like this to
make our code much safer to work with
and another thing i should really point
out is that in practice
casting like this is usually done in
functions where you are passing a base
pointer or a base reference as a
parameter and in this function you
somehow need to call a non-polymorphic
function so you might do something like
this and take the pointer and turn that
into a derived pointer and if the
transformation is successful you're
going to call your method and if the
check fails you're going to follow here
and print an error message you can do
something like this with pointers and we
can do exactly the same thing with
references but here because we want to
do this check we're going to transform
our base reference into a derived
pointer and call our method on the
derived pointer instead this is going to
give us the ability to do this kind of
check to make our code much safer to
work with a word of caution here
overusing down casting is a sign of bad
design if you find yourself doing this
kind of thing a lot to call
non-polymorphic function that's maybe a
sign that you should make that
non-polymorphic function
polymorphic because that's going to save
you from doing this kind of
transformations a lot just make sure you
don't overuse this and do it in a few
cases where you really need to do this
kind of thing now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is dynamic casts
we're going to grab our template files
and we're going to put them in place
let's do that and we are going to grab
the files that make up our inheritance
hierarchy we're going to put those in we
have animal dog and feline and this is
going to make up our inheritance
hierarchy here once we have this in
place we can open this up in visual
studio code by dragging and dropping
here and this is going to give us our
files okay we have our files in here we
can open up the animal class which is
our base class we can see that it is
really simple it's just going to have
one virtual method which is brief it's
going to have a single member variable
which is description here we can derive
from this and create our feline class
which is going to inherit publicly from
animal feline is going to set up its own
method which is non-virtual
and we will have a virtual method called
run we can override in downstream
classes if we want to do that and let's
look at the implementation for feline
cpp if you want to do that you can take
a look it's just going to forward the
construction to the base class to build
the base part of us
let's look at dog dog is going to
inherit from feline and it is going to
set up a simple virtual function called
work and it's going to have a virtual
destructor now we know that we should
really put in
virtual disruptors if we happen to even
have a single virtual method in our
inheritance hierarchy because that's
going to make events easier now we want
to go to the main cpp file and play with
dynamic casts we're going to remove
whatever it is we don't need here and
that we can include our most derived
class let's include doug here this is
going to implicitly include
both feline and animal because this
header is going to include its parent
and its parent is going to include its
own parent this is the logic here we are
going to start out by using a simple
example here and show you that you can't
really call non-polymorphic functions
from a base pointer that is managing the
derived object and here we have an
animal pointer it is a base pointer and
it is managing a real feline object in
memory but if we try and call a
non-virtual function through this base
pointer this is going to blow up this is
not going to work because
we can't really call a non-polymorphic
function through a base pointer because
that's not a virtual function the
requirement to be able to do this is for
the function to be virtual and do some
feeling thingy is not a virtual function
that we know at the base level so this
is not going to work by default and if
we're trying to build code like this
this is going to give us a compiler
error let's pass this through gcc we're
going to do that we are going to finish
the world with errors and if we go up
we're going to find that class animal
has no member name to do some feline
thingy so this is the compiler error
here this is not going to work if we
need to do something like this one
solution might be to do dynamic casts
that we are learning about in this
lecture here and the syntax is
ridiculously simple so we can go down
here and put in a simple separator to be
able to follow this lens on our
powershell window you can do this if you
want and we're going to do our dynamic
cast for example if we wanted to do a
transformation and transform this to a
dark object this would give us a problem
and let's try and look at this again we
have a feline object here and we are
managing this through a base pointer and
what we want to do is to take this space
pointer and turn it into
a dog object if you look at this
remember that we don't really have any
dog information in our feline object
this is going to just go up to the level
of feline but we want to transform this
to a dog to make this super clear let's
look at our inheritance hierarchy again
what we have is a feline object and the
information we have really goes up to
this level
and we are managing our feeling object
through a base pointer this is the setup
we have but we want to do the
transformation and turn this base
pointer into a dog object and this is
going to blow up especially if we have
any dog specific member variables this
is going to blow up this is not going to
work if we try to access dog information
through
what we get through the transformation
to animal to dog we're going to get a
crush because we have no such
information and we're going to look at a
simple example to really drive this home
so what we're going to do is go back to
our dog class and we're going to put in
a sample member variable we're going to
make it private and for example we can
make this a member variable to keep
track of the speed for the dock we can
do this and we're going to initialize
this to 0 by default and we're going to
set up a function which is going to
print some dog information let's go back
to feline and copy the do some feline
thingy method and we're going to do some
dog thingy that's what we're going to do
here i am going to put in this method
and adapt it a little bit we're going to
do some dog thingy and we're going to
account for that in the body but we also
want to print the speed for this dog
here so we're going to say speed and
we're going to print this out suppose we
have this kind of setup in our
inheritance hierarchy here a dark object
has some doubt specific information it
has an additional member variable which
is m speed here we won't worry about
initializing this from the constructor
you can do that if you want all we
really want is to add some extra data at
the dog level and we're going to see
that if we try to transform to doug this
is going to give us a few problems so
what we want is to turn this animal base
pointer into a dark object let's do this
we're going to
change this to dog and the result object
we get is going to be a dog pointer and
we want to call the do
some dog thingy
method on the pointer we get as a result
of this transformation here let's see
what happens you're going to see that
this is not going to give us any
indication that we are doing something
wrong but if the transformation here
fails this is going to silently fail and
store junk data in our feline pointer
here and here we're going to try and
call a method that is going to possibly
use some dog stuff on the feline object
this is going to blow up again we don't
have dog information in this feline
object and the do some dog thinking
method is going to try and print the
speed of the dog that we don't really
have we don't have any dog information
so we have no business accessing dog
information from this object to start
with so this is going to blow up and
it's probably going to give us a crash
let's try and build and see what happens
we're going to pass this through gcc
like we always do the boat is going to
go through you see that this is going to
even blow up at run time when users are
actually using your application this is
super dangerous we're going to run this
and see what happens you see doing some
dug thingy and it's going to try and
print the speed the compiler is really
trying its best but this is really going
to fail and we are crashing our program
if you go down here and say done to make
sure we know when the program is done
and we try and run our program again
let's pass this through gcc to take into
account this thing we have on line 20.
the book is going to be good you're
going to see that the computer is going
to try and really run this but it's
going to see that it doesn't really have
any dog information and the computer is
not going to succeed because we are
trying to access this dub specific
information really on a feline object so
we are going to get a crash again the
message
is that this dynamic casts can fail
and we need a better way to do some kind
of checks before we call our methods
here and we can do this by just using
the pointer we get from this
transformation here so we can say if
feline pointer and check and see if we
have some valid data in this villain
pointer and if that's the case we're
going to do whatever we want to do with
this pointer here okay so this is
something we can do
and if the transformation fails we're
going to fall in this else block and we
can put some nice message here instead
of letting the user crash at runtime
this is much better in my opinion so
we're going to say couldn't do the
transformation from animal pointer to
dog pointer because we really have no
dog information and this base pointer
that we have here this is something we
can do so we're going to say sddc out
i'm going to say stdendl here and we're
going to see what happens let's build
hopefully we're not going to get the
crash because we are doing something
smarter now we are checking to see
if we have any dog information in this
pointer before we call some doubt
specific method on this pointer here
this is the beauty of this we're going
to clear and run rooster now you see
couldn't do the transformation from
animal to dog and our program is no
longer crashing it is ending properly
and this is much better this is what you
should aim for so again the
transformations here may fail
but
if we turn this back to doing v-line
transformation let's do feline pointer
we're going to change this to fill in
pointer again and we're going to do some
feline thing now we're going to bolt
again and this is true
we're going to bolt again and this is
going to build successfully and it is
going to probably do some filament
thingy the build is good we can clear
and run rooster this is going to work
just fine and our program is going to
end properly so here we just saw that we
could do a transformation from a base
pointer to a derived pointer and this is
going to work just fine we can also do
the transformation for references let's
say that here and we're going to go down
and put in a simple example to drive
this home we're going to have a feline
object we're going to set up a reference
to it and if we try and call a
non-virtual method on this base
reference this is going to blow up
because
the base class has no information about
this non-virtual method that we declare
at the feline level this is going to
blow up if we try to build our program
we're going to see that we get a
compiler error saying no such method
as
do some feeling thing we're going to see
that here no member named
this way at the animal level
this is the compiler error we get if we
try to call a non-virtual method through
a base reference that we have here this
is not going to work but we can also do
a dynamic cast and transform from a base
reference to
a derived reference and the syntax to do
that is really here we're going to set
up a
derived reference in this case it's
going to be a feedline reference we're
going to initialize this with a dynamic
cast transformation and the result of
the cast is going to be used to
initialize this reference here and we're
going to be taking
a base reference and turning that into a
derived reference here this is the
syntax the output you desire is going to
be within this angle brackets and the
input is going to be through this
parenthesis here if this succeeds we
will be able to call our method here and
this is going to work just fine let's
try this out
we are going to put in a separator to be
able to follow these things let's put
that at line 24 here this is going to do
and we're going to try and build our
program we're going to pass this through
gcc the boat is good we can clear and
run rooster now we're going to see that
we are doing some filling thingy through
a reference and this is super cool we
can do this you can do this kind of
transformation here and at the end you
see that we are calling our destructors
on our objects and this is a good
reminder that we didn't properly release
the memory on this animal pointer that
we had
so we are going to go down at the end of
the program and release that memory this
is good practice and hopefully you can
see how easy it is to forget to release
some memory that you allocate for
with the new operator this is a good
learning experience here but this is a
good learning experience here but we're
going to fix this problem we're going to
say animal one and we're going to
release the memory now if we run the
program we're going to see that we are
releasing two objects when the program
ends we're going to clear and run
rooster and the destructor is going to
be called two times once for this guy
and a second for this guy this is what
we want and you see that because we have
virtual destructors in our classes we
are destroying at each level so here we
are destroying at the feline level and
we are destroying at the animal level
and this is going to properly release
the memory from our inheritance
hierarchy here so now you know that you
can do a transformation of references
using dynamic casts
but with dynamic cast we have no way to
check and see if the transformation was
successful again if we try to turn this
into a dark reference we can do that and
we're going to say dog reference here
and we will try and call the do some
duck thingy method this is not going to
give us an indication of a problem but
this is going to crash at runtime
because we don't really have any dog
information in our
original feline object here so if you
try and transform this reference into a
dog reference this is obviously not
going to work because we have no dog
information in this to start with let's
boil and show you the problem the book
is going to be good so we can clear
and run rooster you're going to see that
we are going to terminate our program
with the band cast and this is going to
crush you see that we don't get to the
point where we print done and we are not
even going to get a chance to release
the memory that we have allocated in
this main function hopefully you can see
that this is really bad so with
references we have no way
to check and see if the transformation
was successful and this is a limitation
that's why in most cases i usually do my
transformations through pointers and
there is a way you can even turn this
base reference into a base pointer and i
am going to show you how you can do that
so we are going to go down here and try
to change things a little bit we are
going to say doing proper checks with
references and we're going to put in a
piece of code to play with us and what
we're going to do we're going to take
the
base reference and turn that into a base
pointer this is the syntax here again
the input is the base reference but the
output we desire is a base pointer and
this is possible in c plus plus this is
going to work just fine now we are going
to go on top and comment this
problematic transformation we just tried
to do and we're going to try and build
and see if this is actually working
if this transformation succeeds we're
going to do some villain thingy if it
fails we're going to say couldn't cast
to feline reference and we're going to
say that we are sorry this is a good
output message if we get something wrong
we're going to build this with gcc and
see if this actually works the world is
good we can clear
and run rooster you see that this is
working just fine we're going to hit the
end of the program and we are going to
destroy our objects here this is super
cool
but
if we try and do the transformation and
transform it to a dark object even if we
know that we don't have any dog
information in this object that we are
referencing to start with we hope that
we're going to get a good message and
the program is going to end properly
we're not going to get a crush so let's
make sure we are transforming to dog
here we're going to pass a dog pointer
as our output and we're going to store
this as a dog pointer even if the name
is still vlan pointer hopefully this is
not going to confuse you even if this is
named feline pointer it is a dot pointer
here because we just want to see
if we get the error message that we have
here so we are turning this reference
into a pointer and the benefit of this
is that a pointer can store
null pointers and we can use this to our
advantage to check and see if the
transformation here was successful if it
was successful we will call some dog
thank method let's say that here and if
this fails we're going to say that we
couldn't transform to doug and this is
going to give us a nice message and our
program is not going to crash we're
going to build this again with gcc what
is going to be good as you see here
we're going to clear and run rooster now
you see that we are saying we couldn't
catch the dog reference and our program
is not crashing so if you have a
reference to start with and you want to
do some proper checks after you do the
transformation to a derived pointer or a
derived reference this is the best of
both worlds you can do something like
this and your program is going to be
much safer the last thing i want you to
see is that these kinds of dynamic casts
are really useful if you are passing
base pointer or base references into
functions and here i am going to put in
a bunch of functions the first one is
going to take a base pointer the second
one is going to take a base reference
and it is going to say do something with
animal pointer and do something with
animal reference and inside we're going
to do our thing here we're going to take
the animal pointer turn that into a
feline pointer and we're going to do our
proper check and we're going to do some
feline thingy if the transformation was
successful we can do something like this
we can also do exactly the same thing
with references we're going to take our
input reference we're going to turn that
into a derived object and we can call
our method on this pointer and we're
going to do proper chats because we have
a pointer which has a concept of node
pointer that we get if the
transformation here fails this is the
setup we can use in our c plus programs
and we can use these methods to get
derived pointers that we can call even
non-polymorphic functions on and this is
going to work really well so we can go
down and comment out everything i guess
to make this super easy to follow but i
don't think we need to comment out
everything we can just comment out what
we just did here and we're going to be
reusing the reference we have here and
the pointer we have all the way to the
top so we're going to go down and put in
a separator here we can do that and
because of this separator i don't think
we even need to comment things out we
can remove our comment and leave the
code in because i want you to see that
super easily and we're going to call our
functions here we're going to say do
something with animal pointer and we're
going to pass an animal one which is a
pointer and we're going to say do
something with animal ref
we can do something like this and we're
going to pass an animal
ref we have this reference here and we
can do something like this you're going
to see that this is not going to give us
any kind of problem and it is going to
work just fine that's world we're going
to pass this through gcc the photo is
going to be good we can clear and run
rooster and down here you see that in
function taking base pointer doing some
feline thingy in function taking some
biz reference doing some feeling thingy
and this is working really fine this is
what we want in our c plus plus programs
this is really all i wanted you to see
in this lecture hopefully you didn't
find it confusing again the message is
that you can do dynamic casts to
transform from a base pointer to a
derived pointer or to transform from a
base reference to a derived reference as
we did
right here but transforming to a derived
reference has a drawback in that you
don't have a way to check and see
if the transformation was successful so
if you want to be able to do chats you
can do something like this and turn a
base reference into a derived pointer
and then we can check and see if the
pointer is not a node pointer if it's a
no pointer we will know that the
transformation failed and we will print
a good error message if the
transformation was successful we will
have a valid pointer in here and we will
call our derived non-polymorphic method
on our pointer this is going to work
really fine the last thing i want you to
see before we wrap up this lecture is
that dynamic casts are only going to
work with polymorphic inheritance
hierarchies so for example if we try and
turn a double into a string obviously
that's not going to work with the
dynamic cast but let's try and do that
to really show you that this is going to
give us a problem we're going to say
sddc out and we're going to put in a
separator here and we're going to set up
two variables one is going to be a net
for example and we're going to say data
we're going to put in a 45 and if we do
a dynamic cast to an sdd string for
example that's not going to work we're
going to say std string yana str meaning
that this is a string we're going to say
dynamic cast let's say we want to turn
this into an sdd string for example and
the input is going to be our data if
you're trying to do something like this
this is going to blow up you see that
even visual studio code is giving us a
squiggly line so this is not going to
work just make sure you use dynamic cast
in an inheritance hierarchy that
supports virtual functions this is the
design purpose for the dynamic cast if
you use this outside this context you're
going to get undefined behavior or even
compiler errors if you are lucky let's
try and weld and show you this we're
going to pass this through gcc and we're
probably going to get an error saying
that we can't transform from an integer
to a string for example let's go here
cannot dynamic cast so basically it is
saying dynamic casts are meant to work
only with pointers or references but
even then let's see if we can transform
from an end pointer to a string pointer
let's try and do that let's say we want
to turn the address of data or let's set
up a pointer to be explicit we're going
to say data ptr and we're going to
initialize this with the address of data
we can do something like this and we're
going to cast data ptr to an std
strength pointer let's see if we can do
this because it is meant to cast
between pointers and references but you
see that this is even not going to work
so you shouldn't really do something
like this if your input and output are
not part of the same polymorphic
inheritance hierarchy again dynamic
casts are meant to cast
from base information to derived
information and the input and output
must be part of the same polymorphic
inheritance hierarchy this is the
information i am trying to convey here
so this is bad don't do something like
this if you do this you're going to get
undefined behavior or you're even going
to get a bunch of compiler errors if you
are lucky this is really all we set up
to do in this lecture showing you that
you can use dynamic casts we are going
to stop here in this lecture the next
one we're going to show you what happens
if you try to call a polymorphic
function from a destructor
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there in this lecture i am going to give
you a warning and that is to never call
virtual functions from constructors or
destructors i am going to repeat this
never never call virtual or polymorphic
functions either from constructors or
destructors and we're going to explore
why we're going to be using this
inheritance hierarchy we're going to
have a base class called base how
creative we're going to inherit from
base and create derived which is our
inherited class and we're going to be
using this to explore why we can't call
virtual functions from constructors and
destructors
this is what our code is going to look
like the base class is going to have a
protected member variable it's going to
have a bunch of virtual functions
we will have a virtual function to set
things up and it is just going to set
the value of our member variable to 10
and we're going to have a virtual
function called cleanup which is going
to maybe do some cleanup we're going to
see how this works out we also have a
method to get the value but i don't
think we will use this but you can keep
this and if you want notice that we are
trying to call the setup method from the
constructor
and you see that we have a comment that
says that this is going to do static
binding but we're going to see why in a
minute so this is our base class we can
derive from this class and create our
derived class we're going to inherit
publicly
and we are going to override the methods
we have in the base class we're going to
override the setup method as you see
here we're going to override the cleanup
method and
our destructor is also going to be
virtual because we are good c plus plus
citizens and this is the setup we have
once you have your inheritance hierarchy
set up you're going to do something like
this because you want polymorphic
behavior you're going to set up the base
pointer and you're going to use that to
manage a derived object and you can do
something like this now
considering this statement here i want
you to think about the order in which
constructors and destructors are going
to be called we have touched on this
subject before and we are going to
revisit this because it is really
important
in terms of calling virtual functions in
destructors and destructors
so when we do something like this the
base part of this object is going to be
wealth first so we are going to call the
base constructor first we're going to
set up the best part of us after that
we're going to set up the derived part
of us and we're going to call the
derived constructor
and after the derived part of us is set
up we can use our object like we do
always so we're going to use our object
to do whatever it is we want to do when
the time comes for this object to be
destroyed we're going to destroy the
derived part first
and then we're going to destroy the base
part first
now that we have considered this order
try to think about the setup when we
call a virtual function
from a constructor that's what we're
going to look at first the best
constructor is going to be called but
notice that by the time we call the base
constructor the derived part of us won't
be set up yet so if we try to call a
virtual function in the base constructor
there won't be a derived part to call
the most specialized method for so the
compiler will notice that we don't have
a derived part yet we will be at this
stage building the base part and if we
call a virtual polymorphic function we
want the most specific parts to be
called which should live in the derived
part but we haven't done the derived
part yet we are still building the base
part of us so the compiler is going to
notice that we don't have a derived part
and it is going to call the base version
of our virtual function that's why we
said that if you call a virtual function
from a constructor or a destructor
you're going to get static binding
results if you call a virtual function
you want the most specific version
called but we don't have that yet in the
base part because the derived part
haven't been set up that's why we get
static binding results i hope this makes
sense and we're going to get to the same
result if you try to call a virtual
function from a destructor if we get to
the point where our object needs to be
destroyed the derived part is going to
be wiped out first we're going to be
left with the base destructor and when
we hit this base destructor and call a
virtual function
that would mean to call the most
specialized
version of that method but the derived
part of our object has been already
wiped down so this is no longer existent
and we are trying to call the method on
this so the compiler is going to do the
next best thing it can do it is going to
call the best version of our virtual
function and again we are going to get
static binding results that's why it
isn't really wise to call a virtual
function either from a constructor or a
destructor now some of you must be
asking what if i really need to do setup
and clean up in the way that we set up
these things in our classes what if this
method is really useful maybe it is
setting up things we're going to be
using in our application we really need
this and the most logical point to call
this is the base constructor well you
shouldn't really put these in a
constructor what you could do
is maybe call this virtual method on
your object directly when the object has
finished being a constructor that's
going to be a better place to do this
because if you put that in a constructor
or a destructor you're not going to get
dynamic binding results and that's going
to be really bad so to sum up calling a
virtual function
from a constructor or a destructor want
to give you polymorphic or dynamic
binding results the call will never go
to a more derived class than the
currently executing constructor or
disruptor
and we will get static binding results
this is the idea i want to convey here
and as a guideline you should never call
virtual functions or polymorphic
functions from constructors or
disruptors if you really need this the
next best thing you can do is to call
your virtual functions directly on your
object after the object has been
properly
set up we can do something like this and
call our setup method and then we can
call cleanup when we think that we need
to clean up and you call cleanup after
you construct the object and you call
delete after you clean up your object
this is going to do whatever it is you
want to do with your polymorphic
functions and the calls to these virtual
functions want to be leaving inside a
constructor or a disruptor and this is
going to work really well now that you
know this we're going to head over to
visual studio code and play with us a
little more here we are in our working
folder the current project is
polymorphic functions and the structures
we should really say with constructors
and instructors but this is going to do
we're going to grab our template files
and we're going to put them in place and
we are going to open this little guy in
visual studio code by dragging and
dropping here this is going to give us
our main cpp file we can clean up a
little bit remove whatever it is we
don't need and i am just going to put in
my classes i am going to do that in the
main cpp file because that's going to be
much easier to follow we have our base
class it is going to have a single
member variable called m value and we
will have a virtual destructor
we will have a bunch of virtual
functions one is going to be setup which
is going to set our value the other is
going to be cleanup which is going to be
doing some cleanup here we will also
have a getvalue method which will get
this value and print it out if we want
but it is really not that useful here we
will also create a derived class which
is going to inherit publicly from base
it is not going to have its own member
variable all it's going to do is set up
a bunch of overrides for
the virtual functions we have in the
base class we're going to override setup
and in derived we're going to set our
value to 100 and we're going to clean up
and put a message that we are cleaning
up here once we have this set up we can
head over in the main function and set
up a base pointer which is going to be
managing a derived object a classic
setup for polymorphic behavior so we're
going to say base and i'm going to say p
bass and we're going to say equals new
derived this is going to give us our
object which is managed by a base
pointer and one thing i didn't show you
is that we are calling the setup virtual
function
from the base constructor this is what
we want to see we want to see what is
happening here now if we call this setup
function
we would expect polymorphism to kick in
because this is a virtual function
if the derived part is available we will
call the most specific setup function
and that would set up the value to be
100 here if we get the value that's what
we would get let's see what we get here
if we try to get the
value that we have in this object here
so we will get auto value and we're
going to say p base get value we have
this function here and we will try to
print this out okay this is something we
can do in our c plus bus program and
we're going to see the value we get
because we are calling this virtual
function we expect polymorphism to kick
in and if polymorphism kicks in we're
going to call the most specialized
version of our virtual function here
that would be the override we have in
derived and that would give us 100. so
one would get to get 100 printed out
here but let's see what we get we're
going to run this through gcc our
favorite compiler the builder is going
to be good we can clear or bring up a
powershell window we're going to clear
now and run rooster we're going to see
that the base constructor is going to be
called base setup was called you see we
called the base version of this and the
derived constructor will be called and
we're going to see that the value
doesn't exist oh we didn't put the value
out let's do that my bad here we're
going to build again we're going to use
gcc to build and the world is good we
can clear and run rooster now we see
that the base setup method was called
and set the value to b10 and we are
really getting static binding results
because we are calling the setup
method from the base class and the base
version is being called so this is
classic static binding behavior but we
want polymorphic behavior to be working
here but we just saw the reason why this
is in the slides by the time we call
this virtual function we haven't set up
the derived part of us yet
and we have no way to call this virtual
function which lives in the derived part
of us so the compiler is going to do the
next best thing it can do it's going to
call the best version of this method and
we are going to get static binding
results and we are going to get the same
results if we try to call a virtual
function from the destructor for example
if we go in our destructor here
let's see if we can find it we're going
to go in our instructor here and say
this and say cleanup can do something
like this and you're going to see that
the cleanup version we call is the base
version of cleanup
and we don't really want to do something
like this we want the most derived
cleanup version to be called but we
won't get that because by the moment we
call this virtual function from our base
class
the derived part will already have been
wiped out so it won't be available and
the compiler will do the next best thing
it can do it is going to call the best
version of our cleanup function here i
hope this makes sense
again to really drive this home i
realize this can be confusing to many
people especially beginners if we are
calling a virtual function from a
constructor we will call that virtual
function when we hit the base
constructor but by the time we hit the
base constructor the derived part of us
hasn't been constructed yet so if we try
to call a polymorphic function needing
to hold the derived implementation that
won't be available and the compiler will
do the next best thing it can do it is
going to call the base version the same
phenomenon is going to happen in the
destructor when we are done using our
object we will destroy the derived part
information first and when we hit the
base destructor and call a virtual
function there won't be a most
specialized version of the virtual
function because the derived part has
been already destroyed and it doesn't
exist anymore so if we call a virtual
function from the base destructor we
will get the best version called and
this will give us static binding
behavior this is what we are
experiencing here okay so let's try and
run this program and see what we get we
will print out value here which is going
to give us static binding results but we
want to see which version of cleanup is
called this is what we want to see here
we're going to run the task to build
with gcc the world is going to be good
as usual we're going to clear and run
rooster and i'm going to see base
constructor called derived constructor
called and we're going to have a value
which is a junk value because we never
initialize this value but we don't see
our destructure is called what is going
on here
let's investigate this a little more the
reason is we are not explicitly
releasing this memory here through the
base pointer let's do that we're going
to delete p base here and we're going to
run again we're going to weld with gcc
now our destructors should be called
we're going to run rooster and we are
going to see that the base cleanup
version was called and again this is
giving us static binding results you
don't want something like this so if you
want to
get to this behavior i would advise not
to call the cleanup or setup functions
inside constructors or destructors and
that's the guideline i gave in the
slides you should really never call
virtual functions either from
constructors or disruptors especially if
you are doing this from a parent class
hoping to get the most specific virtual
function called through polymorphism if
you want to do that the best thing you
can do is to call the cleanup functions
and
is to call the setup and cleanup
functions after your object has been
properly constructed or before your
object gets to be destroyed so what you
can do here is call the setup method on
the pbes pointer here let's do that and
we're going to call setup this is going
to call our virtual function and we are
going to get polymorphic behavior this
is going to print a 100 as we expect
because it will call
the derived version of setup here and
before we delete our object we will need
to call the cleanup function if we need
to do some custom cleanup here so i'm
going to say
base and call the cleanup function and
this is going to give us the behavior we
want we're going to build our program
pass this through gcc the both is going
to be good we can clear
and run rooster and we are going to see
that this constructor was called derived
constructor was called we will call the
derived version of setup our value will
be 100 and when we get to release or
clean up our memory the derived version
of cleanup will be called and then we
will destroy the derived part of us and
then we will destroy the base part of us
this is going to work in line with the
behavior we are familiar with with
polymorphism and this is really cool so
this is what you should do you should
never call virtual functions from
distractors and constructors because
that's going to give you static binding
results and what you want in this case
is really
dynamic binding behavior this is really
all i have to share in this lecture i
hope you found it interesting we are
going to stop here in this one the next
one we're going to learn about the type
id operator that can come in handy
especially if you want to debug
polymorphic code in your c plus plus
program go ahead and finish up here and
meet me there in this lecture we're
going to learn about pure virtual
functions and abstract classes and pure
virtual functions are a mechanism we
have in c plus plus
to mean that the method isn't meant to
be implemented
in the base class
here we have a simple inheritance
hierarchy to try and drive this home the
base class is shape and we are deriving
from this class to create a circle class
and on the other side we are deriving to
create a rectangle class if we look in
the shape class we have two virtual
methods one is going to be used to
compute the perimeter of the shape
the other is going to be used to compute
the surface of the shape but if we go
down in our inheritance classes we're
going to see that we have the same
methods these are going to be overrides
of what we have in the base class
but the special thing about this
inheritance hierarchy
is that we don't have implementations
for these methods in the base class here
and this is by design if you think about
it this is an abstract shape we don't
know if it's a rectangle we don't know
if it's a circle we don't know if it is
a triangle so we don't really have
concrete information we can use
to properly compute its perimeter and
its surface so it makes sense to really
leave in the declaration for these
methods but leave the implementation
details to inheriting classes because
these classes are going to have concrete
information we can use to reliably
compute the perimeter and the surface
and we can get this information here
so in c plus plus we mean this kind of
design by setting up these methods as
pure virtual functions
and what this is going to tell the
compiler is these methods are not meant
to be implemented in the base class they
are meant to be
overridden and implemented by
inheritance classes and another side
effect of this is that the compiler is
going to prevent you from creating
objects of this class because it really
doesn't make sense to create an object
of shaping your design
if you want to be able to compute its
perimeter if you want to be able to
compute its surface so why bother
creating an object that you won't really
be using in your c plus plus program the
meaning for this base class is just to
be a an idea or a representation of a
shape without really going into the
concrete implementation of how that
shape really works
hopefully this makes sense so let's see
how we can do this in code here we have
a simple class which is going to be our
shape class we are going to have two
virtual functions we're going to have
the perimeter function we're going to
have the surface function these are
going to be virtual functions or virtual
member functions i should say but we are
going to make them
pure virtual functions by using the
syntax you see here so we're going to
prepare an echo zero and this is going
to tell the compiler that these are pure
virtual functions once you set up these
functions a few things are going to
happen in your class this class is going
to become an abstract class in that
you want to be able to create objects of
this class anymore if you try to do that
you will get a compiler error another
thing is that you don't need to put in
implementations for these methods
because you marked them as pure virtual
and what this means is that the
implementations will be put in by
inheriting downstream classes because
they will have concrete information to
compute the perimeter or the surface as
we have here so we don't need to bother
with definitions for these functions
here if you even try to put in a
definition here you're going to get a
compiler error because this is a virtual
function we have no business putting an
implementation in the base class here
these are meant to be implemented by
downstream inheritance classes okay once
we have our ship class and our
inheritance hierarchy we can try to run
this in our code for example if we try
and create a shape object we're going to
get a compiler error because shape is an
abstract class so we can't create
objects of it and i don't think i made
this super clear once you set up at
least one pure virtual function in your
class the class is automatically going
to become an abstract class and what
that means is that you want to be able
to create objects of this class so this
is an abstract class we have here and if
we try to create an object of it as we
are doing on this line here this is
going to give us a compiler error but we
can still use a base pointer to manage a
derived object
a common setup we do with polymorphism
so for example here we can set up a
shape pointer and use this to manage a
rectangle object if we call the surface
member function on our base pointer this
is going to do a polymorphic call and we
will get the surface of the rectangle
and we're going to print this out here
you're going to see that this is going
to work we can also use the base pointer
to manage a circle object as we see here
if we call the surface method this is
going to do polymorphism and it is going
to call the surface version of the
circle class and we can see it printed
out here this is the design we can
achieve even if shape is an abstract
class we can't create direct objects of
shape as we are doing here but we can
use a base pointer or a shape pointer to
manage derived object through
polymorphism and you need to be aware of
this okay now that you have an idea
about what a pure virtual function is
and what an abstract class is
let's see a few ideas you need to keep
in mind if your class has at least one
pure virtual function it will become an
abstract class you already know this you
can't create objects of an abstract
class if you try to do that you will get
a compiler error another thing i don't
think amid super clear is that derived
classes from an abstract class must
explicitly override all the pure virtual
functions from the base class
if you leave in any
pure virtual class that you don't put in
an implementation in for your derived
class is also going to become an
abstract class and you want to be able
to create objects of that you need to
keep this in mind another thing you
can't do you can't call the pure virtual
functions
from the constructor of the abstract
class if you do this you're going to get
a compiler error because we don't have
implementations for these things so this
is not going to work the constructor of
our abstract class is used by deriving
classes to build the base part of our
derived objects but they are not meant
to be used from the outside because we
can't really create an object of an
abstract class so now that you notice
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with this a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is pure virtual
functions and abstract classes we are
going to grab our template files and put
them in place and we're going to paste
them in this project here and we are
going to grab the files that make up our
inheritance hierarchy you are going to
get these files from the resource
section of the course if you want you
can download them and use them like i am
using them here or even better you can
type the code and see how these things
really work that's the best way to learn
i do recommend that but we want to save
on time here so i am just going to reuse
these glasses that i have lying on my
drive i am going to open this in visual
studio code by dragging and dropping
here we have our shape class here this
is going to be our base class you're
going to see that we have our member
variable which is going to be the
description for our shape we have a
bunch of constructors here but the most
important thing here is that we have a
bunch of pure virtual functions here and
if you go in the cpp file you're going
to see that we don't have
implementations then for the perimeter
and surface functions these are pure
virtual functions and we have no
business putting in an implementation in
the base class once we have these
virtual functions in and mark them as
pure virtual functions by prepending n
equals zero here this class here is
going to become an abstract class and
what that means is that we can't create
objects of this class it is meant ready
to be inherited from and downstream
inheritance classes are going to be
forced to
override these methods here otherwise
they are themselves going to become
abstract classes we're going to have a
chance to look at this here we also have
our rectangle class which is going to be
inheriting from shape it is going to
override our two methods we're going to
override the perimeter function we're
going to override the surface function
for rectangle the perimeter is computed
this way we're going to multiply
the width by two and the height by two
and we're going to add these two things
up we're going to compute the surface by
multiplying width and height and this is
going to give us the data we want we can
look at circle it is going to also
inherit from shape and it is going to
override our methods here if we want we
can even put in a radius and a variable
to keep track of pi we can do this you
can really do this however you want this
is just going to allow us to compute the
surface relatively easily in this class
here let's look at the implementation
nothing special here this is just going
to forward the construction of the base
part of us to the
base constructor and this is going to do
whatever it is we want to do here let's
head over to the main cpp file and
actually use these things
we are going to include circle and
rectangle let's do that circle dot h and
we're going to put in rectangle that h
and we're going to first try and create
a shape object let's do that we're going
to say shape and say shape pointer and
this is going to be new shape we can use
a default constructor and if we do
something like this you're going to see
that we're going to have a compiler
error here we have a squiggly line but
if we bring up a terminal window and
look at the problems tab we're going to
see that object of abstract class type
shape is not allowed so shape is an
abstract class now
and why is it an abstract class because
we have an at least one pure virtual
function here we actually have two and
this is going to make our shape class an
abstract class what that means is that
we can't create objects of this class
and if we do that we're going to get a
compiler error let's try and build this
program we're going to pass this through
gcc our favorite compiler we are going
to see that the bolt is going to fail
we're going to have a bunch of errors if
we go up and look at the error we have
invalid new expression of abstract class
type shape
so we can't really create an object of
this let's go down and see what these
errors are saying note because the
following virtual functions are pure
within shape and they are going to try
and really be helpful in the errors that
they give here and all they are saying
is that we can't create objects of this
class because we have pure virtual
functions inside okay now you know this
if a class is abstract you can't create
objects of that class but you can still
use a base pointer to manage derived
objects of that class so let's comment
this out because this is going to make
our code not compile and we're going to
say that this is going to give us a
compiler error and we're going to try
and use the base pointer to manage a
rectangle object we can do this so we're
going to set up a shape pointer and it
is going to be managing the memory of a
rectangle object we're going to go
through the base pointer and call the
surface method and this is going to call
the implementation in rectangle because
our base pointer is really managing the
rectangle object if you want you can
even use the type id operator to print
the dynamic type of this shape rect
pointer you're going to see that it is
managing a rectangle you can actually do
this because we learned about that in
the last lecture so let's practice that
we're going to say dynamic type of shape
wrap and we're going to say type id and
we're going to de-reference the pointer
we're going to say shipwrecked and we're
going to print the name of this and
we're going to see it print out on our
powershell window and after this we are
going to print the surface that we got
from this call here and we're going to
see what this gives us let's try and
build this program we're going to pass
it through gcc our favorite compiler the
bullet is going to be good we're going
to clear and run rooster we're going to
see that the dynamic type is rectangle
you can see that right here so the base
pointer is really managing a rectangle
object and this is what we have here and
if we call the surface method we will be
calling the method on the dynamic type
so we will be calling this surface
method on the rectangle class and we
will be
using the implementation we have here so
the surface function that is going to be
called is what we have on line 20 in
rectangle here and this is going to just
be a multiplication of width and height
and we're going to get 100 here because
our width and height happen to be
10 and 10 so multiplying this is going
to give us 100 as we see here this is
really cool this is what we expect we
can even use our base pointer to manage
a circle object so let's do that we're
going to put in a separator to be able
to follow this easily and our output so
let's say stdndl here and we're going to
put in the code so we're going to set up
a base pointer which is really going to
be managing a circle object here and we
will call our surface method this is
going to call this method
polymorphically because surface is a
virtual function
so we will get polymorphism here and we
will call the surface method on the
circle object which is really our
dynamic type if we print this out we're
going to see the surface printed out but
if we want we can even print the dynamic
type of our
base pointer here so we're going to do
the same thing we did for rectangle we
can use our type id operator to print
the dynamic type of shape circle and
we're going to say shape circle here and
this is going to do what we want let's
look at this we're going to be printing
the surface here this is exactly what we
want so let's build and run we're going
to pass this through gcc the bolt is
going to go through as you see here if
we clear
and run rooster we're going to see that
the dynamic type is now a circle so the
base pointer or the shape pointer we
have here is really managing
a circle object polymorphically so if we
call a virtual function on this base
pointer it is going to call
the most
specific implementation of the surface
object we have and that happens to be
for this circle object here this is what
i mean
if we compute the surface we're going to
see that it is going to be using the
data we have here and we will get this
number as our surface if you plug this
in you're going to see that this is
really right so this is really all i had
to share in this lecture we can set up
pure virtual functions in a base class
and what that's going to do it is going
to make our class an abstract class but
we want also be able to put in
implementations for these
methods anymore in the base class
because they are meant to be
overwritten and implemented by
downstream inheritance classes so if you
go in here and try to put in an
implementation we will probably get a
compiler error because this is not
allowed you see we have a problem here
if we try to build we will get a weird
compiler error let's make sure we see
the compiler error so world finished
with errors and we are going to see
what's the problem here let's go up and
see
pure specifier on function definition so
this is not allowed so we are really
conflicting ourselves here we are
marking this function as a pure virtual
function
and what that means and a pure virtual
functions isn't meant to have a
definition but we are also putting in a
definition here so the compiler is going
to be confused this is not something we
should be doing another thing i want to
point out before we wrap up this lecture
is that
downstream inheriting classes are forced
to override and implement all the pure
virtual functions from the class that
they inherit from if they don't do that
they are themselves going to become
abstract and we want to be able to
create objects of them so let's try and
for example comment out the surface
implementation here and that's going to
make our circle class an abstract class
and if we try to create an object with
circle we will get a compiler error
because now circle is an abstract class
let's try and build and show you the
compiler error and this can really be
confusing if you are a beginner on this
you will be wondering why you can't
create objects of your class even if you
didn't really explicitly put in any pure
virtual function the reason is we are
inheriting from an abstract class that
has two pure virtual functions but we
are only overriding one pure virtual
function we need to override all of them
otherwise our class is also going to be
an abstract class let's look at the
compiler error we are getting here let's
go up and see if we can find it we are
going to say in function in main
evaluate new expression of abstract
class type circle we are trying to
create an object from an abstract class
this is the error we have here and you
should really note this
so let's go back and make sure we are
overriding all these stunts because we
need to do that to be able to create
objects of a circle and now this is
going to work exactly as it should let's
build and make sure of that the bullet
is going to be good we are fine this is
working exactly as we want this is
really all i wanted you to see in this
lecture i hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this one
the next one we're going to learn about
interfaces in c plus plus and they are
going to be reusing the knowledge we
learned about in this lecture go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there in
this lecture we're going to see that we
can model interfaces in c plus plus
using abstract classes
and now there's a lot of things that
might not make sense in what i just said
so let's break this apart an interface
can be thought of as an abstract class
with only pure virtual functions and no
member variable so if you have a setup
like that you can call that thing an
interface let's look at a simple example
here here we have a simple class called
stream insertable you see that it
doesn't have any member variable it only
has a pure virtual function here and a
helper function that we could set up to
help us do a few things the only
specification to make this an interface
is to have in only pure virtual
functions and no member variables if you
have in a member variable this is going
to stop becoming an interface in c plus
plus okay so you can think of an
interface as an abstract class
with at least one pure virtual function
and no member variable that's going to
make it an interface down here you see
that an interface can be thought of as a
specification of something that will be
fully implemented in a derived class
but the specification itself is going to
reside in the abstract class another way
to think about an interface is to treat
an interface as a thing
you can attach to your types to give
them superpowers for example this stream
insertable interface
has a single job and that's going to
allow our types to insert data into
output streams like sddc out this is the
only thing this interface is going to
add to our times so we can take this
interface and attach that to a point
class for example and we will
automatically be able to print point
objects to the output stream and we want
to need to overload the stream output
operator in the point class we can do
the same thing to our bird class we can
do the same thing to our dog class and
we will be able to print these things
without having to overload the stream
output operator hopefully you can see
how powerful this is if we manage to set
up this kind of relationship between our
type and our interfaces so again an
interface is something you can attach to
your types to give them powers or
features that they originally didn't
have and that's going to save you from
having to implement these features
separately in each class for real time
so this is a huge time saver now you
must be asking how do i take my
interface and attach it to my type well
the way c plus plus does this you have
to inherit from the interface from your
type to attach the interface to your
type so for example if we wanted to
attach this interface to our point class
what we would do is something like this
we would set up our point class
and inherit from our interface which is
stream insertable the moment we do this
our point is going to be able to print
thanks to the console through the stream
output operator but hopefully you can
see that something is missing how does
our point class know how to print stuff
if we go up and look at our stream
insertable interface we're going to see
that it is declaring a stream output
operator it is this thing that is used
to print data to the output stream you
see this is a regular output stream
operator we will be printing to sddo
stream and the object is named out here
and we will be printing whatever operand
that is passed as a second parameter
here but the catches
we will need to set up a virtual
function
that will need to be implemented by
whoever inherits from our interface here
and this is going to be super powerful
we are going to take over the job to
print to the output stream but we will
let inheriting download classes to
specify what we print and they are going
to specify that in this virtual method
let's look at our point class again and
really put the puzzles together here and
understand how this works okay this is
our point class and it is going to be
inheriting from our interface and it is
going to implement our virtual function
here we are going to set it up here and
we are going to mark it as an override
because it is overriding a method that
comes from our stream insertable
interface here and it is going to
specify which data we print to the
output stream and how the data is going
to be printed out you can specify
these things here we're going to format
the data in a point and we're going to
be using these square brackets to put mx
and my here and notice that this is an
override so the inheritance class has
all the information we need to put in
our output stream operator and we will
do that through our stream insert
override here now let's go back to our
stream insertable interface to see how
our output stream operator actually
works what we have here is what would be
a header and this is going to just put
in a declaration for this but we can
even look at its implementation the
implementation for our output stream
operator may look something like this we
are going to pass in the first operand
and the second operand here but notice
what we are doing here we are going to
call
the stream insert virtual function on
our operand here and this is going to
call
the most specific implementation we can
find for the stream insert if we are
trying to print a circle for example
this is going to call the stream insert
override on a circle object if we are
trying to print a point this is going to
call this method on our point object and
this is going to use polymorphism
because our second operand here is pass
by reference hopefully you can see how
this is super powerful i know this is
convoluted because we are jumping around
trying to explain this but i couldn't
really come up with an easier way to put
this we have to try this encode to
really see the power of this but this is
really the power of interfaces we can
design our features and wrap them in an
interface and we can really attach that
interface to any type we have in our c
plus plus program and that type is going
to automatically inherit the features
that we have set up in our interface for
example now that we have attached this
interface to our point here we can print
our points on the output stream and this
is going to work automatically you see
that we don't need to set up an output
stream operator on our class altogether
we can even go further and attach this
interface to a full inheritance
hierarchy for example if we have our
base class to be animal and we inherit
from this class to create all kinds of
crazy classes we can go on and attach
our interface to the base class here and
this is going to make all our classes in
our inheritance hierarchy have the
features that the interface has brought
to the base class so for example we can
attach our interface to the animal class
by inheriting from stream insertable
here and this is going to give our
animal the powers to be printed out to
output streams and this is going to be
powered by the virtual function that we
are overriding here you see
we are going to specify which data to
print in our animal class and how the
data is going to be printed out here and
we can do that in this override and this
is super powerful once we do this we're
going to go to each class in our
inheritance hierarchy and implement the
stream insert
override because if we don't do that
this class is also going to become an
abstract class because it is inheriting
from a class that has a pure virtual
function remember if you inherit from a
class that has at least one pure virtual
function you will be forced to implement
all the pure virtual functions that come
from your parent class if you don't do
that you are going to become an abstract
class yourself and we don't really want
that that's why we are overriding the
stream insert override here and with
this we are going to specify which
information to print from our object
here and here we are going to put out
the description and the wing color and
this is the format we specify here and
this method is going to be called by our
output stream operator which is coming
from our stream insertable interface
hopefully you can see how this is super
powerful okay now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in our working folder
the current project is abstract classes
as interfaces we're going to grab our
template files and put the data in place
and i'm going to copy this and put that
in here
we are going to put in the files we're
going to be using in our inheritance
hierarchy you see we have our animal
hierarchy here you can grab these files
from the resource section of this
lecture and you can reuse them like we
are using here or if you want you can
even type this but i don't really
recommend this because this is too much
typing we just want to learn about
interfaces here and that's what you
should focus on so we're going to open
this up in videos video code and this is
going to give us all the files we need
we're going to look at the top class and
we will see that it is inheriting from
our stream insertable interface so let's
look at our stream insertable interface
because this is the focus of this
lecture here so it is a regular class as
you see here it is class stream
insertable we're going to set up an
output stream operator and it is really
like any other output stream operator
you have seen we're going to pass the
second operand by reference
and we are going to specify our pure
virtual function which is going to be
implemented by downstream inheriting
classes from this class here and this is
going to set up polymorphism and what
this will do
is if we call this method on our second
operand here we are going to call this
method polymorphically so if you are
trying to print a point we are going to
call this method on a point object and
we will print it out exactly how the
point wants to be printed if we are
printing a circle we will call this
stream insert method on the circle and
we will print a circle exactly how a
circle wants to be printed out let's
look at the implementation and it is
nothing really complicated we're going
to specify our output stream object as
the first parameter here and the second
parameter is what we want to print out
we will pass this by reference and this
is going to allow us to do polymorphism
remember that stream insertable is
really going to become our top base
class so we will basically be setting up
stream insertable polymorphism here you
need to keep this in mind we are going
to call our stream insert method on our
operand and we're going to pass the
stream output we want to print on and
we're going to return this output stream
to really make this behave
like a regular output stream operator to
allow output chaining in our operator
here once we have this stream insertable
interface we can really use it however
we want let's head over to the main cpp
file and try to play with us so what we
are going to do is crack this open and
we are going to remove whatever it is we
don't need we are going to include our
interface so we're going to include
stream insertable let's do that
insertable.h i think this is the name
and we're going to set up a point class
which we wish to be printed out on the
output stream notice that we want to
inherit from stream insertable and what
this is really doing is attaching the
interface to the point class here and
because this stream insertable
interface has a pure virtual function
we need to
override this pure virtual function here
if we don't we want to be able to create
objects of our point here let's go down
and show you that we're going to get
that problem if we don't do that we're
going to say point
and say p1 and for example put in 10 and
we will have a compiler error because
now the point class is an abstract class
because it is inherited from a class
that has a pure virtual function and it
is not overriding that pure virtual
function
so in other words this class still has a
non-implemented pure virtual function
that's why it is
an abstract class and we can't create an
object of it if we're trying to run this
code we're going to pass this through
gcc we will get a compiler okay we have
a compiler error here and we need to fix
this all we need to do is to implement
the interface that comes from our stream
insertable interface here so we can grab
our pure virtual function and implement
it in our main cpp file for the point
class we're going to put it in here and
we will remove the pure virtual function
specifier here and we will put in an
implementation we want to specify that
this is an override of a method that is
coming from our upstream parent class
and we are going to head over in the
body of our function and put in the
information we want to put out
this is a point object so we just want
to print the m x coordinate and the m y
coordinate here and this is the format
that we want and at this moment the job
of this function is really done
and it will be picked up polymorphically
if somebody tries to call this on a
point object through polymorphism and
this is going to work now that we have
this point we can try and build and make
sure this is working let's make sure we
don't have the compiler error anymore
the world finished successfully so we
are cool here but what we want to see is
that we are able to print
point objects because that's the whole
point of attaching this interface to our
point class here so what we are going to
do is print this out we're going to say
sddc out we're going to say p1 and we're
going to say p1 here this is how we
would use our output stream operator you
see we don't have a compiler error this
is really magic some of you are going to
ask how is this even working somebody is
going to look at your class they are
going to look you don't have an output
stream operator but you can print your
objects so how is this working well this
is working through the magic of
interfaces we are attaching this
interface to our point class and this is
going to give our class the powers that
come from this interface and one of
those powers is to use the output stream
operator we get from this interface we
can use that directly and what this is
going to do let's look at the
implementation of this interface this is
going to just call the stream insert
virtual method on the object that we
pass as a second parameter in this
operator here and the second parameter
happens to be the point that we are
printing here so what this is really
going to do
is something like this we're going to
try and figure out what the compiler is
going to try and do we are going to say
p1 and we're going to say operator
stream output and we're going to say
stdc out that's the stream we want to be
printing to
and the point we want to print is p1
this is basically what the compiler is
going to do and it is going to print our
thumb and this method is available in
our stream insertable header and it is a
friend of our interface that's why we
are able to do something like this
accessing the data from our interface
let's build and actually show you that
this is going to work we're going to
pass this through our gcc compiler the
build is going to be good so we can
clear not clear we're going to control z
on this and we're going to bring up a
powershell window and we're going to
clear this time and run rooster you see
that we are creating our point here and
this is really cool we can even
uncomment this and we're going to use
sddc out because the compiler is going
to take this and turn that into this and
we have the ability to have code that is
much more readable by c plus plus
developers out there we're going to
build and run this again the build is
going to be good we can clear and run
rooster and this is going to print our
point here this is really cool but this
is not the end of our store we can even
print an entire inheritance hierarchy
look at what we did at our animal class
here we attached this interface to our
animal class and the moment we do that
we need to override the pure virtual
function
that comes with this interface and
that's what we did down here we have
overwritten the stream insert
virtual function
and in the body we're going to specify
which data we want to print and how to
print that data that's the whole point
of this override we are doing here we
are going to do the same thing in each
inheritance class from animal for
example if we go to feline we're going
to do exactly the same thing we are
going to inherit from animal and this
will indirectly inherit from our
interface so
we need to override
the pure virtual function that comes
with that interface and we do that here
we're going to specify which data we
want to print in this case we're going
to put the description out and the first
style and we are going to specify the
format in which we want the data to be
printed out again that's the whole point
of overriding this virtual function here
we're going to do the same thing on each
inheritance class in our inheritance
hierarchy for example we did the exact
same thing for doug
we did the exact same thing for a cat
and we're going to do the same thing on
our bird classes that's exactly what we
do here specify which data to print out
and how the data is going to be printed
out and this stream insert override is
going to be picked up by our interface
when we get to call the output stream
operator here notice that we are calling
this thing polymorphically we are
calling our stream insert
method on a reference that we pass here
and this is going to resolve this using
dynamic binding this is going to work
really well now that we have this setup
we can head over to the main cpp file
and really do all kinds of crazy things
let's put in a separator here and we are
going to
play with us we are going to include the
classes we need to set up our animals
and we are going to put them in here we
have animal feline dog cat bird pigeon
and crow the moment we do this we don't
need to put in this stream insertable
because it is coming in directly from
this but we don't need to worry about
this because we have include guards in
but we are going to be using smart
pointers so let's include the memory
header and we can set up an animal and
try to print it out we will be using
polymorphism so we will go through a
base pointer to animal and use that to
manage a dog object here we are just
going to pass in the data and we will
try to print this animal out notice that
we are going through a base pointer
calling the output stream operator so
this is going to resolve
the call to stream insert
polymorphically and it is going to print
this information at the dog level and
what i mean by that is that if we go in
dog we're going to find our stream
insert that's going to print this
information here
like we want to print a dog and this is
super powerful hopefully you can see how
cool this is we're going to try and
build this program we're going to pass
this through gcc the boat is going to be
good we can clear and run rooster we're
going to see that we print this as a dog
even if we used a base pointer to try
and print this out how cool is this we
can even use this to set up a bird and
print it out we're going to set up a
base pointer that is going to be
managing a bird you can see that we are
using a unique pointer here you can
really use any kind of smart pointer you
want we're going to print this out and
this will be printed out like a bird
wants to be printed out and that's going
to be using
the override from our bird class and
that's going to say bird is going to put
out the description it's going to put
out the wing color and this is really
going to work really well we're going to
pass this through gcc again the world is
going to be good we can clear and run
rooster you see that we are printing out
bird here and this is using polymorphism
combined with interfaces and this can
come in handy if this helps your
application depending on what you want
to achieve with zipclose plus we can
even put our animal data in an array and
try to print that out so we're going to
put out a separator to be able to follow
this nicely in our output terminal this
is going to do and we're going to go
down and put in the code to play with us
we're going to share an array of shared
pointers this is how we do this and
we're going to initialize this with all
kinds of crazy animals we're going to
put in a dog we're going to put in a cat
we're going to put in a crow and a
pigeon and we will be managing this
through base pointers notice that this
is an array of base pointers
and we're going to be calling the output
stream operator polymorphically so for
the first element here we will print a
dog how a dog wants to be printed out so
we will be using the stream insert
override from the dog class if we go
there we're going to see that we're
going to prefix our data with dog if we
hit the second element we're going to
print this like a cat wants to be
printed down the third element is going
to be printed out as a crow the fourth
element is going to be printed out as a
pigeon and this is going to fall in and
work
right away down here you see that we are
looping calling our output stream
operator and this is going to work
really well let's try and build this
program we're going to pass this through
gcc the build is going to be good so we
can clear and run rooster and you're
going to see that we are printing our
information here the first thing is a
dog the second thing is a cat the third
thing is a crew the fourth fan is a
pigeon and this is working really well
hopefully you can see how interfaces can
be powerful in your c plus plus design
use this if it makes sense for whatever
application you are designing with z
plus plus my main goal here is to
introduce you to the idea of interfaces
and how powerful they can be again an
interface is something you can attach to
your type in c plus plus
and at the moment you attach that
interface to your type your type is
going to have the powers that come with
that interface and all you need to do in
your deriving classes is to implement
the virtual functions that come with
that interface and the interface will
pick them up and use them to do whatever
it is you want to do
polymorphically and that's going to be
really cool we are going to stop here in
this lecture this one we're going to try
and recap what we saw in this chapter
go ahead and finish up here and meet me
there